welcome to this course on deep learning
for computer vision with tensorflow in
this course you'll Master deep learning
Concepts and their applications in
computer vision tasks such as image
classification object detection and
image generation you'll learn about
tensors variables and neural networks
including convolutional neural networks
through practical projects like
predicting car prices and diagnosing
malaria you'll also learn Advanced
Techniques for model performance data
augmentation and deployment as well as
learn about modern convolutional neural
networks transfer learning and
Transformers Envision this course comes
from neural learn which offers a variety
of machine learning courses hi everyone
and welcome to this course on deep
learning for computer vision by
noahlearn.ei in this course we shall
make use of tools like hog and face
tensorflow Onyx and 1db to build and
deploy AI are different computer vision
Solutions applications of computer
vision are everywhere today going from
Tesla self-driving cars to livestock
farmers who can now automatically count
the number of animals they have to
mobile facial recognition apps and even
in the hospitals where the
gastroenterologists could make use of
computer vision for much faster
Diagnostics
behind those different computer vision
Solutions is deep learning models like
the convolutional neural networks and
the vision Transformer throughout those
course we shall explain in detail how
The Confident or the vision Transformers
work given that these are all deep
learning based models let's look at the
high level how deep Learning Works let's
suppose we want to build a system where
we get an input like this one and we are
able to say that this is a damaged car
or get an input like this one and we say
that this car is still intact then in
that case we could build and train a
deep learning model which takes in this
image for example and then
for its output here we'll be able to see
that this car is damaged or in the case
where this model takes in this other
image
then we'll be able to set up this car is
intact nonetheless for this our deep
learning model to be intelligent enough
to make this kind of decisions we need
to train it and the way this training is
carried out is we have thousands
hundreds of thousands or even millions
of damaged cars like this and so our
output level is obviously damaged on the
other hand we have thousands of cars
which are still intact and the output
level is intact and so now we have what
we'll call a data set that is those
inputs and the corresponding levels and
then in this uh deep learning model
right here we stack several neural
network layers so we'll have this
we have some other layer some other
layer right up to the output now it
should be noted that this neural network
layers here are essentially mathematical
functions if you do not have a
background in mathematics you shouldn't
be worried as in this course we shall
focus on implementing all this
practically so that said as we're saying
this we have here all these layers this
neural network layers we have here are
essentially mathematical functions and
if we have a linear layer then this
means that we could take an input X
multiply this by a weight which we'll
call W and then add some bias which
we'll call B and then this gives us the
output which is that output of a given
layer so here for example let's suppose
this input is X we have X here we'll
take X multiplied by the weight and then
add up the bias to have the output at
this level y let's call this X1 then
this is y1 and then this y1 will be used
as inputs to this next layer and then
we'll have Y2 right up to say y n and so
during the training process given that
we know the input and the output our aim
will be to obtain the values of this W
and this B which
in short end when we pass in images like
this or this the model is able to know
whether it's a damaged or an intact car
now we see that at every layer we have
our weights and biases
which are all going to be updated during
the training process making use
obviously of our training data that is
this inputs and your corresponding
levels such that when shown an image
which this model has never seen or deep
learning model is able to take the right
position so in essence this kinds of
models are called The Learning models
because we have several layers stacked
between the inputs and outputs and the
number of layers we stack represent the
depth of our model on the other hand
deep learning algorithms fall under a
category of artificial intelligence
algorithms known as machine learning
where the model learns from the training
data a prerequisite to this course is
knowledge of Python Programming so you
could head over to the neural learning
YouTube channel and check check out our
free essential Python Programming
playlist which should help you master
the basics of Python Programming let's
now take a look at what we'll be
learning in this course the way we've
designed this course is such that will
start from the very Basics so we'll
suppose that you have no prior
experience in deep learning and so we'll
start with basic topics and tensorflow
like the tensors and the variables and
from here we'll dive into solving our
first practical problem which is that of
car price prediction now it should be
noted that although this isn't
necessarily a computer vision problem
this will permit us learn how to prepare
our dealer with tensorflow build simple
models like the linear regression model
train these models evaluate them and
test out this model such that by the
time we move into our next project which
happens to be now a computer vision
based project which is that of malaria
diagnosis we already have what it takes
to start building more complex models
like the convolutional neural network
but before building them we'll first of
all understand how and why they work by
the end of the section we should have
learned how to build a simple solution
for our malaria diagnosis problem and so
now we're ready to dive into building
more advanced models with tensorflow
after looking at this more advanced
models we'll then dive into evaluating
classification models so we'll look at
different metrics like the Precision
recall accuracy and then we'll learn how
to come up up with the confusion Matrix
and the ROC plots once we're done with
this we'll dive into model performance
here we shall look at tensorflow
callbacks learning rate schedulers model
checkpointing and then how to solve the
problems of overfeeding and under
feeding that said one main way in which
we could mitigate the problem of
overfeeding is by using the
documentation and so we have the section
reserved for the augmentation using
tensorflow and augmentations now once
we're done with data augmentation we'll
look at more advanced concepts in
tensorflow like custom losses and
metrics the eager and graph modes then
custom Training Loops so learn how to
train our model without necessarily
using the fit method we'll look at
tensor word integration where we'll
learn how to carry out data login
reviewing model graphs hyper parameter
tuning then profiling and visualizations
from here we'll get into machine
learning operations with weights and
biases where we shall look at how to
carry out experiment tracking hyper
parameter tuning data set and model
versioning with 1db and now we shall
move to our next project which is that
of human emotions detection
um again here we shall prepared data set
build our model carry out data
augmentation and then we shall look at
tensorflow records now once we're done
with the section we shall go ahead to
look at modern convolutional neural
networks like the Alex Nets vgg Nets
resnets mobile Nets and the efficient
net with all this in place we'll learn
about transfer learning we should help
us now train our models much more
efficiently using already pre-trained
convolutional neural networks then we'll
look at how the convolutional neural
networks take Decisions by visualizing
intermediate layers
and so up to this point so far we've
been looking at the convolutional neural
networks and now we'll be set to dive
into the vision Transformers would
understand how to work and even get to
fine-tune our own Vision Transformer
using the hog and face Transformers
Library
and so now that we have a working
solution the next logical step will be
to deploy this such that anyone around
the world could make use of a model
which we've just built and so we'll
convert our trained model to the Onyx
format would quantize this build out a
simple API and then go ahead to deploy
this API to the cloud now that we've
learned how to deploy our computer
vision models to the cloud we could dive
into other computer vision problems like
object detection
and in this section we'll look at the
basics of object detection and also
build and train our own object detection
YOLO model from scratch with tensorflow
then finally we'll dive into the domain
of image generation where we'll look at
the variational auto encoders and the
generative adversarial neural networks
which we shall use for digit generation
and phase generation in this course the
coding platform will use to build and
train our models will be Google collab
we shall make use of Google's free gpus
to train our models we've just explained
that in order to train a model like this
one we make use of a training data set
which has its inputs and its
corresponding outputs those inputs and
outputs are multi-dimensional arrays
which are commonly known as tensors
in the section we shall start with
tensor Basics then we'll move on to
Casting and tensorflow we'll look at
initialization
indexing Broadcasting
algebraic operations Matrix operations
commonly used functions in machine
learning would look at the different
types of tensors like the react tenses
sparse tensors and even the string
tensors in the context of deep learning
tensors can be defined as
multi-dimensional arrays
an array itself is an ordered
arrangement of numbers it's important we
take note of these keywords as the data
we shall be dealing with like for
example this image right here can be
represented using this numbers which
have been arranged clearly in an ordered
Manner and can be represented in
multiple dimensions in the specific case
we have this array which is represented
in one two Dimensions So This Is A 2 Z
or two dimensional array or what we
generally call a matrix
now we'll explore different types of
arrays based on the dimensionality so
here for example we have what we'll call
a Zero Dimensional array which is simply
because this array or this tensor
contains a single element so let's say
we have 21 this is a Zero Dimensional
array let's say we will have one this is
Zero Dimensional so on and so forth so
essentially once we have a single
element then it's a zero D
um array
and then now for our next example we
have this 1D cancer right here which in
fact is a combination of several Zero D
tensors so if you look at this you see
that this is a zero detention this is
another zero detensor this is another
zero detensor so this Vector is made of
three of these kinds of elements now you
could have other examples like this
let's say we have five
um eight and then three oh let's let's
change the length so let's say we have
one of length five for example we could
have 10
2 11 4 and 7. so this is a 1D tensor we
have right here so so far we've looked
at the zero detenter we've looked at the
1D tensor and now we could dive into the
2D tensor which essentially is made of a
combination of several 1D tensors you
could see that right here this is a 1D
tensor here this is another one detensor
this is another 1D tensor
and finally here we have a 1D tensor so
when you bring together this one the
tensors you form this 2D tensor for a
three-dimensional tensor you might have
guessed this right you would simply
combine several two dimensional tensors
so right here we have this 2D tensor
with this other 2D with this other 2D
and this other 2D forming uh to v d
tensor
we could visualize this differently here
so we take this this this and this now
you see we have one two and
um the third dimension now that we
understand this we're gonna take a look
at the concept of tensorships starting
with this given that it's Zero
Dimensional then there is no shape with
this one here it's one dimensional and
it's made of three elements
and so we could see this is of ship
three
so we have three and that's it now for
this other one
it's made of
one
two
three
and four One D tensors and each and
every one of this is made of three
elements so this year for example this
made of three elements this made of
three this three this three and given
that there are four of this made of
three elements its shape is four
by three so that's it that's how we
obtain the shape for this now for the 3D
tensor we have here is made of one two
three
four two D tensors so this here we have
four two uh two detenters and each and
every one of this is made of two 1D
tensors where each and every one is made
of three elements so what we'll see here
is this is two by three this year
because we have one two is two by three
this is two by three and this year is
two by three and now given that we have
four of these different two by three
um two detenters then we would see the
shape of this 3D tensor is four by two
by three so similar to this we have four
by three this is four by two by three
now notice that the number of elements
we have here tells us or gives us
information about out the number of
Dimensions our tensor is so here because
we have a 1D tensor or one dimensional
tensor we have just one here because
it's 2D or two dimensional we have two
and here because it's 3D we have three
also in Matrix notation we would say
that this year or this Matrix right here
is made of one
two
three
and four rows so number of rows we have
here is four and then here we have one
two
three
columns number of columns is
in the case of this 3D tensor we have
right here we have one two rows and one
two three columns for each and every one
of this to the tensor we have right here
now we have some basic knowledge on
tensors let's go ahead and create them
with tensorflow so first things first
would import tensorflow as TF and then
you should note that because we're using
collab we do not need to install
tensorflow before making use of it all
we need to do here is just import and
we're good to go now first thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna have our tensor
which we'll call tensor 0d and the way
we're gonna create this tensor is by
calling on the constant method so we
have tensorflows constant method and
then we specify for example that we want
this to be let's say four so that's it
that's how we
um create a Zero Dimensional tensor
you could see here from the
documentation that this constant method
takes in a value takes in a data type
takes in a ship and
um a name
but for now we pass in only this value
right here and then we could go ahead
and print this so let's have denser
um Zero D run that you could see right
here we've had the sensor which has
value 4 it has no shape And it's of type
int32
with this we could go ahead and
um build out our tensor 1D tensor 1D we
have as usual our constant method but
this time around because it's 1D we're
gonna have a list
we're going to take this list we had
here two zero negative three
and then putting this now right here we
have two zero and negative three now
let's print this out we have tensor 1D
and there we go you see we have the
value
which is this 1D orders list
we could see shape right here and then
the data type now let's modify this and
say we have eight and less than 90.
let's run this now and check out as chip
you see here this is our new list all
this on your tensor and then you see now
it's five because we have five elements
in here
but again this is still an integer so
let's add this here changes to a float
and then see what we have see here now
this is a float so it's still
um our inputs by the time around floats
um same shape but the data type changes
from int to float let's get back to
integer and then we move now to the 2D
tensor so we've looked at 0d 1D to
create a 2d tensor it's going to be
quite as simple as we've done with the
Zero D and One D so yeah we have two D
and then we have that's usual uh
constant and then
um let's open up this square brackets so
we have the square brackets right here
opened up and then we'll have
this 2D tensor we have seen already so
let's
have this right here we have one two
zero
we put a comma to move to the next row
or to the next line we have three five
minus one
then we have one five six and then we
have two three eight okay so as you
could see here we have this 1D tensors
which we stuck and which will form our
2D tensor now as usual we have a
constant metal which takes in this value
and you should also take note of the
fact that we have this outside of this
stacked 1D tensors now we have this
let's go ahead and print out tensor to D
we have to answer to D
and there we go as you could see we have
our 2D tensor that's it we have the
shape four by three which is what's
expected and then the data type is in
32.
from here we move on to the 3D tensor
which is essentially made of this 2D
tensors which have been stacked together
so let's go ahead and see how to create
this with tensorflow
we'll start by putting together those
two detenters we had one two zero
three five minus one so that's it
three five minus one and then we have
all those remaining 2D
um tensors so let's get here we have
tensor three tensor three D
as a constant
we have our square bracket here and then
we simply copy this copy this and then
paste this in here
now let's
um print this out and see what we get so
here we have denser
three
d
as you can see we're getting an error
and this comes from the fact that we
omitted commas now if you look at this
you'll see that uh between 1 1D and
another 1D to form this 2D there is a
comma and so this means that between
this 2D and this other 2D there should
be a comma so let's have this comma here
let's have this comma let's have this
comma and this comma okay so let's run
that again and see what we get
as you could see we have this our 3D
output of shape four by two by three and
that's exactly what we expect to get did
it type in 32. now before we move on we
could we should note that we could also
do let's let's have this here we could
also do
um tensor
3D shape to obtain this um tensorship so
you see that we have that
um right there we could replace this
zero
you could have one see that's zero
that's one that's two
um there we go let's let's have one
that's one
um that's it okay and also we could also
have here let's say three we could do
ending and this gives us a value of
three showing us that our tensor is a 3D
tensor at this point with look at uh
Zero D One D two D and even the 3D
tensor let's go ahead and check out a 4D
tensor but the Constructor for the
tensor would need several 3D tensors so
let's have this here we have this 3D
well we saw this already this is this 3D
and then we move to this other one right
here or these two others we we have this
other 3D and this other 3D and then now
if we stack this three 3DS up what would
obtain will be a 4D tensor see we have
this one we add this other and we have
this other so now we have here of four
dimensional tensor which is made of
three
three-dimensional tensors now you should
know that this could be two this could
be four this could be whatever number so
if we consider only this two then we're
talking about two three dimensional
tensors but uh what's so important to
note here is the fact that once you
stack several 3D tensors you create a 4D
tensor
now at this point you could take it as
an exercise to create your own for the
tensor so you could pause the video but
um
we're gonna go ahead and show you how to
create this
person's first we're going to take up
our 3D year we have this 3D tensor let's
just copy this
there we go we paste this out here
let's repeat that operation copy and
paste again but now let's modify some
values so let's say we have 13 26 let's
just randomly modify this
um 23 so it's now this these are the 3D
is different from the other one say 30.
okay now let's copy this again and then
paste out here so we have the three
three detensors
um let's say this is one oh let's just
add zeros we have here
um 23
um two four and C2 okay so now we have
our three 3D tensors we have this one
we have this other one and then we have
this other one now to create our for the
tensor as usual we call on our constant
method so we have
4D
um we have the constant and as usual we
have all square brackets which will open
up and then now we just simply take this
and copy all this to the end
cut this from here and then paste this
all year okay so we see we have three of
this
um 3D tensors now remember last time
when you were separating two 3D tensors
or between the three detenters we need
to have a comma so here we're gonna have
this comma and then here we're gonna
have this camera
and here we have comma okay so that's it
so let's run this or let's print this
out and then see what we get so here we
have print
um tensor for the
there we go you could see from here we
have our 4D tensor
you see it's cheap three by four by two
by three
and this is because uh for the tensor is
made of one stick this off it's made of
one two
three three detenters so that's why we
have three
and then uh for each and every one of
this we have four that's one two three
four two detenters so here we have four
and for every 2D tensor we have one two
that's two rows and one two three that's
three columns
and that's now exactly what we have here
so we still have the same data type we
have our values which you could have
here and that's it if we get back here
we'll see that we have different data
types which we could use so instead of
uh does this default int uh we could
have
um TF float say 32 and you'll notice
that the outputs as we have seen already
should have this decimals since we're
now dealing with floats now the float we
have in here is of type
um float32 or specifically the flow 32
meaning that the Precision value here is
32. now if you reduce this if you reduce
this
you'll see that you would actually have
the same output
but the difference is that less memories
are located
for storing this tensor as compared to
maybe even let's say the 64 that's float
64.
and so in set in contexts where we have
the memory constraint we would want to
use the lower precision tensors
in the documentation you could have
um all the different deleted types
um which are supported in tensorflow so
here we have quantized data types and
talking about quantization we're going
to treat this
in subsequent sections and so don't
bother for now if you don't really
Master this
um here we have the brain floating
points here we have the Boolean here we
have complex
and it's 128 and 64-bit versions here we
have the double
which in fact means the double Precision
floating point now this is double
because the flow 32 is a single
Precision so here we have single the
floor 16 is half prediction or precision
and then the double is uh double
precision
here we have the ins and the different
versions or the different uh precisions
or we have the quantized ins
um we have resource we have string
we have unsigned int
and then we have variant
getting back to the code if for example
here we have this float let's just add
the decimal so we suppose that this is a
float and then now we do ins let's see
in 64 we run that you'll see that I
would obtain an error so let's have this
here what do we see we told that we
cannot convert this
um tensor to or to eager tensor of the
data type in 64. but now if we use the
cast method if we do tensorflow cast
um and then your order let's take this
back let's let's have our tensorflow or
our tensor 1D and then let's take this
off or let's yeah let's just have this
float
um 64. there we go or let's say flow 32
and then let's say we Define some casted
tensor
cast the tensor 1D and then discuss the
tensor 1D is simply going to be the
casted version of this or one detensor
so here we have tensor
1D and then we specify the data type and
now we say we want this to be in 16 for
example so yeah we're going to print out
the tensor 1D I also going to print out
the cast that tensor 1D
we get in this error we should have had
t f dot so let's have this year there we
go and then let's look at what we have
as output as you can see thanks to the
casting operation we are able to get
from this float to this integer tensor
and so this tells us that instead of
um coming right here and saying for
example in 16 or let's say in 32 it's
preferable to make use of the cast
method that said let's say for example
instead of having this that's instead of
um casting this into an integer we want
to cast this into a Boolean so let's run
this
you see here that we get all
um true except for this one year which
is false and that's simply because this
is a zero so it looks like the water
casting method does is for all the
values which are different from zero
they're true but values equal zero equal
false
we could also go ahead and create our
own Boolean so let's say we have tensor
tensor bull let's call this tensor Bull
and then we have uh this list made of
this tensor so we could have true true
false
true true false okay so let's print out
tensor bowl and see what we get
as you could see here we have our output
tensor of shift 3 and here is values you
see the data type bull right here now
another data type which you could look
at is um the string so let's let's say
we want to have tensor string
um
there we go let's say we want to have
um Halo World hello world
um let's print this out tensor
string
there we go we have our tensor we could
also put this in the list because right
now this is a Zero Dimensional tensor so
let's put this in the list
and uh
uh hello world hi and we'll close that
and now we have this 1D tensor of shape
2 which is a string from here we would
also look at how to create or how to
convert a numpy array into a tensor so
let's call this
um NP array first of all we'll start by
importing numpy as NP we could just do
that right here import numpy SNP there
we go and then we have
um
NP array
and let's say we have NP array and then
let's take in this here let's say one
two three or one two four there we go
print this out we have NP array right
here
now we could make use of this tensorflow
convert the tensor method so let's say
we have here converted converted tensor
and we have
um convert to tensor which essentially
takes in a numpy array now let's have
this and then print out the converted
um tensor
with that getting back to the
documentation we will look at a couple
of other
methods like the I method here we have
this I method right here as usual we
have the well described method in the
documentation which comes with this
short
phrase explaining how it works it comes
with this different arguments and also
even some examples so getting back here
we told that this I method permits as
construct and identity metrics or batch
of matrices
so now we have this definition we could
simply copy this out and then yeah back
to the call right here
pieces out and let's say we call this
um I tensor I tensor and for now we have
this number of columns which is known
the bad shape known the type flow 32
name known now let's say we want to have
three rows so we have number of rows
which is equal three now in this case
I'll print this out so we see the kind
of output we get here we have I tensor
and there we go as you could see we have
this identity Matrix where all the
values of the Matrix are zero except for
those of the leading diagonal let's um
show clearly this leading diagonal right
here here we have our Matrix which is
this and then we have this element of
the leading diagonal which is equal one
now you should note that you could you
could say for example
um let's say three times this
and you should have all the elements of
the religion diagonal to be equal three
and the order is zero so in this case we
now have someone like this so you see
all these three while the rest zero now
let's get back let's take this off here
we have our eye tensor and then we see
that we could specify the number of
columns now here uh or previously where
this was set to known we had a square
Matrix that is when you define the
number of rows to be three the number of
columns automatically takes up the value
of three so we have a three by three
Matrix and obviously the type here is
flow 32 could modify this and say for
example 16 from that let's try out bull
after this
there we go we have float 16 let's try
out board
you see everywhere is false false false
false false false except for the listen
diagonal which has true
now getting back let's say here we have
five and then now number of columns
let's say this to three
you see right here the output we get now
it's it acts like we have
um a five by five metrics so we suppose
we had a five by five Matrix where this
would be zero zero this would have been
zero zero this would have been zero zero
this would have been one if this was
five by five zero and then your zero one
so this is what we would have had if we
did not uh if we let this to to be known
that is uh number of rows equal number
of columns but now that we've set number
of columns to be three this part has
been cut off and so this is what we're
left with now with that said let's go
ahead and take this back to Norm and
then let's set a bad shape so let's say
this is three
I'll run that
as you could see because we set this bar
shape to B3
um here we have this output which is
three by five by five well let's let's
change this to two so you could see that
this actually
um is responsible for deciding on what
number of batches we have right here so
here we have two by five by five so
essentially saying that you want to have
this by shape to be two like this means
you want two five
by five matrices which are identity
matrices and that is uh which have their
values all zeros except for those of the
religion diagonal which are equal one
and so we see how we could create this
3D Matrix or the 3D tensor from
um the I method now we could go ahead
and say for example one foyer let's run
this
um and see what we get we should get two
by four two by four by five by five so
here we have two by four by five by five
and that's it for the eye method we move
on to the next method the fuel method
here we have a method as defined during
the documentation which creates a tensor
filled with a scalar value so here we
have this fuel method which we're going
to copy but uh before testing out the
code you could see here from the example
that with this field method we have this
tensor which takes or which
has shaped two by three and which has
value 9 on all different positions so
let's get back here
pieces out let's call this fill tensor
and let's say this Dimensions let's say
we have three by four and unless they
want to have the value
um let's say five okay so let's print
this out and see what we get fill
the tensor
and there we go that's the output we get
now let's have this one for example to
run that
see we're able to create this 3D tensor
where all the values or all the elements
in each position takes the value 5. from
here we'll go on to the ones method and
should be noted that this once method is
quite similar to The Fill method in the
sense that this creates a tensor just
like with a few method but the only
difference is that your all the elements
are set to one so you notice that you're
in this definition uh we do not have
this value argument right here we had a
value which we passed but with the ones
there is no value because the value by
default is one so let's have this here
and then it's all right here see we have
this once so we'll call this once tensor
um there we go we specify the shape
let's say five by three and then we
print that out so here we have one
stencil
and there we go we have this output
Matrix which
um is made of five rows one two three
four five and three columns one two
three
where all the elements of this tensor
take up the value one now you could
obviously do this to have or to obtain a
3D tensor
so that's the output we get you see it's
five by three by two
from here we'll look at the ones like
and what this one does is it creates a
tensor of all ones that has the same
shape as the input
so what this means is if you have an
input like this one let's say we have
um 12. let's not make that one 12 1 3
and then five
um seven two this actually a two by
three Matrix let's change this so you
see that this is two so we have the
shape the shape is
um two by three so it's ship is two by
three
now if this is an input here if this is
the input into our ones like method what
will get us output will be
um a matrix or tensor with this same
shape that is we ship two by three so
our output is going to be having a ship
two by three meaning that we're gonna
have
um two rows and then one two three
columns but the output or rather the
values we're going to insert here will
be all ones so now we're gonna have one
hence the name once like so uh this like
is actually for the shape of this so you
imitating the input with respect to its
shape
now getting back here you see we had
this field tensor which is a one by
three by four tensor so let's
um let's have this right here let's say
we want to have uh ones like tensor
there we go TF once like and then we
have fill tensor fill tensor there we go
okay so let's print out this once like
tensor
now before printing let's um try to
obtain the output so here we know that
this is field tensor the shape is one by
three by four so it means that we should
have an output of shape one by three by
four where all these values are once so
let's run that and make sure that that's
the output we have
there we go this is one by three by four
and we have all ones
from here we move to the zeros method so
it's quite similar to the ones here uh
just like with the ones we have
um all elements set to a given value
with the ones all the elements were set
to one with the zeros all elements are
set to zero so that's essentially it now
let's just modify the code a little
right here so this was once tensor
um let's change the shape this three by
two and then instead of once here let's
say zeros here we have zeros and
um let's call this well let's see this
is well let's just copy this out and put
out separately so here we have this we
paste that out here we have zeros
and here we have zeros fine
and here we have zeros okay so let's run
that
and there we go we should have this year
so you see it's three by two three rows
two columns that's fine and all values
are zeros if you were once then you have
all values once and for the ones or the
zeros like is similar to the ones like
so you could take that as a simple
exercise we then move forward we have
this shape method right here where we
told that this returns a tensor signal
of that it returns a tensor containing
the shape of the input tensor so
um
as we had seen before we could obtain
the shape of a tensor by simply
um
making use of that tensor's name dot
shape now if we want to have an output
like in our case now we want to have
this output
um tensor which contains the shape of
our tensor
then we could make use of this shape
method from tensorflow so you see here
we have the same four by two by three
but this is now in this list
um and then we have its shape and we
also have its data type obviously it's
made of integer so we shouldn't expect
to have a float data type right here
another method which we could make use
of is a rank method which simply Returns
the rank of a tensor so it takes an
input and then returns its rank you have
a simple example right here
where we have this 3D tensor T and then
when you call on the rank method you see
that we obtain the output which is three
so let's
um put that out here let's just paste it
out here and test that quickly
there we go as you could see because the
output
um is a Zero Dimensional tensor the ship
it actually has no ship but you could
see its value right here that's three
now if you take out this and take out
this and then
take out this other part here there we
go we run this again we should have a
rank of two this time around
that's fine it's here rank is two
we now move to the size here the size
method which Returns the size of a
tensor so you put in an input
um in the size method and it gives you
the size of the tensor we have as usual
in the example here which we could copy
but before running that we could read
this um node here where we told this
returns a 0d tensor representing the
number of elements in the input of type
output type this is the output type here
which by default is into 32 so let's get
back here and pieces out and check out
the size
as you can see here we have the size of
12 and that's because we have 12
different
um positions or 12 different elements in
our tensor now let's take this off again
take this off
um take this off there we go let's run
that we should have six
so that's it you see we have six and uh
yeah we could also specify this the type
um let's say float
um 32.
we're getting an error here uh got an
unexpected keyword argument D type now
getting back here you see this is
actually out type not D type so let's
get back here and then we have
um out type so we have out
type there we go
run that
and as you could see right now we have a
float instead of an INT
The Next Step we'll take is creating our
own random tensors and that is
essentially creating tensors which take
up random values
now in the case of tensorflow random
normal
our output values are going to be from
or are going to be drawn from a normal
distribution
now we are going to explain at least at
a high level what this really means for
now let's just copy this out and get
back to the code and run this and see
what we get so right here let's say we
have random tensor
there we go we need to specify the shape
so we'll say let's take let's make
um a matrix or 2D tensor so let's just
three by two now you see we have this
mean value standard deviation values
which have been given right year by
default and we're gonna look
um at what this actually means shortly
the data type is flow 32 CDC is no name
noon now let's run this or let's print
this out and see what we get so here we
have random tensor and there we go
as you can see we have the set of values
which are all negatives and if you
notice they are very close to zero so
here we have our particularly negative
one about negative two is negative 0.3
very small number and negative of 0.5
negative 0.87 so these are numbers very
close to seven let's run this again so
you see that we're able to randomly or
generate a matrix
with this shape with random values you
see that it takes up different numbers
it's time around we have a mixture of
positive and negative numbers but again
these numbers are
um very close to zero
now what if we modify this mean so we
modify this mean we'll run this again
let's see what we obtain you see that we
have these numbers now which are instead
close to a hundred and so what this
tells us is that we could make use of
this mean and the standard deviation
to decide on the kinds of random values
we want to have here
now to better understand what is going
on
let's consider this figure from this
probability playground by Adam
curningham from the University of
Buffalo
as you have noticed in the code when we
did tensorflow random
normal
and the mean when we specify the mean
yeah the mean is this mu you have your
when we specify the mean to be equal
zero most of the values we had were
surrounding zero
and when we set this mean to a hundred
when we set it to 100 most of the values
were surrounding a hundred
now this curve you have here actually
explains why so you have this curve
right here uh which is bell shaped
and the idea here is that it permits us
randomly pick values around the mean
that's around zero so that's why you
notice that
at zero we have the highest probability
score here are probably the score is f
of x so
um
for values around or values surrounding
zero that this value surrounding zero
there is much higher probability or
chance
of them being picked as compared to
values far away from zero so let's pick
out these two values let's say we have
um let's say we want to pick out the two
values 0.5 let's say 0.5 and we want to
pick out negative five
you would see from here that the
probability of of us have a negative
five is particle is zero that's almost
zero but the probability of us having
0.5 as you could see from year after
taking this middle the probability was
having 0.5 is about 0.35
now if we change this value and take a
hundred as we didn't with the code let's
take a hundred
we have that
um 100
well it looks like they've fixed this to
six so you cannot go above this you
could play around this like this you go
from negative six to six okay let's say
the mean is six so we have a mean of six
one thing you can notice is that now
this um 0.5 as you could see 0.5 let's
take this off
um 0.5 no longer has a probability of
about 0.35 of being picked 0.5 has a
probability enough about zero have been
picked while negative five also still
has a probability of about zero being
picked but um on the other hand as you
could see here let's take this off you
see that value is like five have much
higher probability have been picked
seven eight six did not have a much
higher probabilities have been picked
now it just means that if this was a
hundred or if we're able to get to 100
then uh we'll be values like 97
or 98 99 100 101 102 and this explains
why when we run this code with this mean
we had values surrounding a hundred and
that's simply because those values
around the mean of um higher
probabilities of being picked
now let's take this back to zero and
then talk about the standard deviation
so we have the zero oh there we go you
see get back to zero and now let's talk
about the standard deviation but before
um getting into any
um explanations let's modify this let's
say we take 10 years okay it looks like
the max is fixed at 2.5 okay so let's
let's say we have that 2.5 one thing you
could notice is we still have this uh
mean at zero we still have our mean at
zero that's it makes sense because we
haven't changed this but our Bell curved
um
ship now appears wider so an increase in
Sigma Sigma here is what we call the
standard deviation so it's what we uh
called STD Dev in the code so we had the
mean and the standard deviation so Sigma
standard deviation the sigma square is
the variance so Sigma square is the
variance anyway uh what we're trying to
see here is an increase in Sigma will
make this curve wider and a decrease
let's decrease Sigma you see
decrease in Sigma makes the curve
thinner and narrower
now what this implies is that if we have
let's say let's get back to this if we
have Sigma Square as 2.5 there are much
higher chances now that we could
um randomly select negative five as
compared to before so if this is
negative five here you see there's a
slightly higher probability of negative
5 and picked as compared to when we
reduce this you see when we reduce this
um you see negative five years
practically zero but when we increase C
negative 5 is at least this time around
having some negligible value
and so this is essentially the row that
the standard deviation plays now if we
reduce this again we find that even 0.5
because this is 0.5 around here even 0.5
let's take this off even 0.5 which used
to have a property of about
0.035 of occurring
um now
has almost no chance of being picked
let's increase it back and set it back
to zero okay
and so that's it at this point we could
modify this we could take this to six
and then take this to 2.5 and you see
that we could take values now between 0
t go from zero to about
um 11. with that said we'll then look at
the uniform distribution or how to
generate random numbers or random values
drawn from a uniform distribution so
again we'll just copy this out and then
get back to the code we'll paste this
year
there we go we have the shape let's pick
um this uh one okay and then minimum
value zero and now we have maximum value
so you see that unlike here where we had
the minimum the the mean and the
standard deviation now we have instead
of a minimum value and a maximum value
so let's let's let's leave the leave it
at this and then let's say we have
random tensor random tensor okay so
let's print this out
let's print out our random tensor
there we go we have random tensor
let's increase this so we have many more
values five run that
okay you see we have this values now
let's let's say we change this max value
and say it's
um
880 or let's say eight okay let's say
eight let's run that and what you notice
now is you have much larger values well
values between 0 and 8. but
um before
the values we're getting where values
ranging between zero and one now this
tells us that most probably this maximum
value by default is one so here uh you
see it's defaults to one you could
always or make use of the documentation
whenever you're in doubt so let's get
back here you see we'll take this to 100
and then see what we get you see we have
this values now between zero and one
hundred now the question you may be
asking yourself is what then is the
difference uh between this uniform and
this normal distribution so let's get
back again here
um in our probability playground and
then let's pick out
um uniform so there as you can see here
many other properties distributions but
we're going to focus on the normal
distribution and the uniform
distribution so we get into the uniform
distribution
and here's what we get so we have a and
b now this is like our mean vowel which
we saw in the code and this is like our
Max vowel so when we say mean vowel
negative one Maxwell one obviously our
values will fall in this range Now by
default this is zero and this is one on
tensorflow so
um that's why you saw the values ranging
between zero and one
now as the term goes it's actually
uniform so this means that all this
um values here
have
equal chances or probabilities of being
picked
and so unlike the normal distribution
where we would have something like this
something like this now we have this
square instead or this um rectangle
and so simply here all we're doing is
picking the range of values which we
want to have or which we want to be
outputted so we could get year increase
this
um well you cannot you cannot uh the
mean cannot pass the cannot be greater
than the max so that makes sense let's
reduce this reduce that see from
negative four to four see we take all
the values well that's it you see there
we go Google from negative one two two
that's it
now one great thing is also the fact
that we could modify this and have ins
so let's run this
and see what we get you see we have only
integers now now let's say we had Norm
let's run that
you see we have an error most specified
Max vowel
in the case where the data type is
integer so this actually
um reading out here in the documentation
so you can see here now that you need to
have this Max file so let's change that
to let's say 1000 so you will get values
ranging between 0 and 1000 so we have
five values
here from the shape we could change this
let's say five by five and then all
those values range between
um zero and one thousand another
argument which we haven't spoken of so
far is this seed argument and here we're
told that this seed argument when used
in combination with tensorflow random
set seed
will be able to create a reproducible
sequence of tensors across multiple
calls
and so in cases where we want to produce
reproducible experiments
will want to set this Global seed value
and also the seed
argument value in this uniform or let's
say normal function
so let's go ahead and copy this out we
get back to the code
there we go let's just run this right
here
let's take off some parts and print this
out so we print this out
then we modify the shape and the max
values so we have exactly the same value
for the seed year which is 10 and then
Here We Set This Global C to five let's
run this
see it outputs four three one four three
two one one one and one three three now
let's create another cell
um let's copy this there we go places
out here and you see we have the same
Global seat
um and then we have the seat of 10. now
let's run this again
and as you could see we have exactly the
same output as this one see four three
one four three one four three two four
three two one one one one one one one
and one three three
now obviously modifying this and taking
for example one
gives us something different if you take
10 again
you see you should have exact same
output
now you also see that here when we take
this off if we take this off and we run
the cell you see we have different
outputs but when we get back here let's
let's run this again see we have another
set of different outputs but when we
take this run that you see we have exact
same output we had already
and now if you want to have more details
about certain seats you could always
check out this um the documentation
now we're gonna move on to tensor
indexing so let's take this example we
have this tensor to be indexed and we
declare this we have the C of the
constant and this 1D tensor in this out
this is what we get now suppose we want
to get this first four elements to get
this for four elements we need to
consider this or the indexes so here we
have the zeroth index
then here we have the first index yeah
the second you have the third and the
fourth so we want the first four
elements all we need to do is
take out those first four elements by
doing this so we have indexed and then
we have the square brackets we start
with a minimum index.0 that's a zeroth
index which is this we go one two three
four
now here we'll specify four
there we go
and as we get we have this first four
elements right here
now you might have noticed that the
fourth index is actually this year but
then since we're starting from zero
our third index happens to be the fourth
value so if we're taking this from zero
we have one two three four so yeah our
first four values now note that if you
want to grow from the zeros uh from the
first let's say we want to go from this
index here 6 to 66. if you want to go
from 6 to 66 why you will have to do is
this we have that we pick out zero we go
start from the first zero one so we have
this one right here the minimum and then
wanna go up to 66 then we'll have to go
one two three four five
now if you put this five right here
you'll notice that it's not going to
give you exactly what you want so let's
run this and then we get that so see
that we have here six two four six we
actually have this instead of all this
so how do we do to get all this in order
to go from one index to say a maximum
index what you need to do is to add this
plus one so if you want to go from the
first index to the fifth Index right
here that's one two three four five
wanna go up to this index and it'll
include I need to put this plus one it's
similar to with a TF the range we had
seen previously where in order to put
out on tensor from let's say a range to
five what we needed to do was to specify
this from two to six so that it will be
like two three four five so yeah what we
did was add to five plus one so it's a
similar kind of
pattern that we're following right here
so to go from this other 66 we need to
add plus one so let's run this now run
that and there we go it is we have
exactly what we expected so let's take
this off now now we have six so with
this we see how we're able to slice out
some parts of this array of this tensor
from here we could also include Stacks
so if we put out say two steps of two
you'll notice that we go from the first
that's the first Index this is the
zeroth index so we'll go to zero we talk
with this one with Skip by two so we
skip this element and then we go
straight to four so notice how we go
four and then from this four we skip
this element and then we go to six to
six so that's it so we could include the
steps right here now by default we have
a step of this one so when we do this
you see we have exactly what we do what
we get when we don't put the stats at
all
so that's it we've seen that in general
we have a minimum value right here and
then we have a max value
or rather a Max index
so yeah yeah we have
so that's it in general we have a mean
index up to the max index plus one so
generally this all we get
now in the case where we don't specify
this mean index as if we have this for
example let's suppose we have the uh
this we don't specify any mean index and
then we go up to four then this is
considered to be zero so you notice that
this two come out with the same answer
we have exactly the same answer right
here
when you specified a minimum value say 3
and you don't specify the maximum we
just gonna go right up to the end so
let's run this we'll see that we'll get
zero one two three so we're going to
start from this and then go right up to
the end so we'll have four six six seven
so that's it we have exactly as expected
four six six seven good time from three
and we're going right up to the end
if we want to go from this first off
from this minimum Index right up to the
last bit one value that is wanna go from
this four right up to six to six what we
could do is have our maximum value to be
negative for one so doing this you'll
see that we have four six six and six so
we're going from this Index this minimum
index so the last bit one value now
let's take this to two see we have four
six take this to three we just have four
take this too far this should be an
error
from this point we'll see how indexing
is down with tenses of Dimension greater
than two so we will start with a two
dimensional tensor which we had to cut
previously now
for indexing to be done we'll start with
a comma right here so we have this comma
and then if we want to get the first uh
the first three rows so we suppose we
want to get this first three rows wanna
get this first three rows and then in
this first three rows wanna get just the
first two columns so I want to get this
column and this column in fact what we
want to get is this one two three five
one five this happens to be the first
three rows and the first two columns so
in order to do this we not as we said
here we have this comma and then to this
left side we have the rows and then to
the right side we have the columns so
what we do here is since we want to get
the first three rows we're gonna go zero
one two so what we're gonna have here
zero right up to three so we're gonna
get zero one two obviously two plus one
three so we have this so it's kind of
like similar to what we've seen already
here but with the difference that all
this uh let's see all this gets to this
left side and then for the columns or
rather for this yeah for the columns we
want to get the first two columns so
what we're gonna have here is zero two
so we'll have that
there we go and then let's run it so
running that we say we have one two
three five one five now let's suppose we
want to get this first three rows like
this and then I want to get all the
columns so basically yeah what we can do
is this so just like you're getting all
the elements we just had to do this
that is with this column here we just
have to put this color right here and
then we're gonna go so let's run that
and we should have one two zero three
five negative one one five six so we've
got in the first
three rows and then all the columns
now if you want to get a particular row
so suppose I want to get just the third
row that's going to get only this rule
right here we're gonna specify as index
this is zero one two so yeah we have two
so for the rows recall we have the left
side representing the rows and the right
side representing the columns so yeah
what we're saying is we're getting the
second index uh this row of the second
index or the third row which is which
happens with this and therefore the
columns to get in each and every column
so let's run this we should have one
five six now if we want to specify or if
you want to get just some of these
columns that's if you want to get maybe
the there's only this color right here
we're gonna have two and then we'll
specify the zeroed column so around that
and we should have one now if we want to
go ahead and take say one right up to
the end you see we have five six because
here we'll specify we want to get the
second row that's zero one two second
row and then for the columns we're going
from one this one because this is zero
one two one right up to the end so
that's it
just like with the rows we could also
specify or we could also get just a
particular column so suppose we want to
get this zeroth column right here which
made of one three one two
so to have that done we're taking all
the rows so we're gonna have all the
rows and then we will pick out just the
zero current so let's run this and we
have one three one two which is this
column right here now let's take this
from here and we'll see we have an error
because we haven't specified how this
rules are going to be managed so here
again let's say you want to take one two
three
so right here we have three one three
one because we're making for the colors
we're taking the zeroth color so we're
taking all this and then for the rows
we're going for one to three so zero one
this is our first this one
two
and then three
meaning that I was typing a two because
stopping at three minus one so we're
going we're taking this and then this
and then this is we're taking the zero
it's column we just have three and one
so that's how we get this
so let's come back we have this and then
if you want to pick out the first the
color on the first index we have two
five five three now this year means
we're picking up all the index indices
so if I'm picking up all the indices
what we could do is specify just these
three dots three dots simply means
picking up everything so we're picking
up all the indexes uh we're picking up
all the rows and then with specifying
the First Column so running this should
give exactly the same output as you
could see right here
we now move to the 3D tensor so we have
the 3D tensor right here let's take this
off now we kind of like this kind of
like very similar to what we've seen
already with the two utensils but the
difference is that we have the two
Commerce now it's kind of why we have
these two commas recall that with three
dimensions we have the First Dimension
the second dimension and the third
dimension
so first in let's put this this way
let's have this
we have this
each of this is a two by three shaped
tensor so here we have two
by three that's what this was not a
shape actually and then here we have one
we have one two three four elements so
we have four elements so this happens
with the shape of our 3D tensor right
here now if I want to pick out just this
first element right here all I need to
do is specify a zero and then I could
take all this all this simply means that
I've picked out this first index and
then taken all the rows and all the
columns so let's run this and you should
get just this right here so you see we
have one two zero three five negative
one so that's fine now if in this index
that if after selecting this index I
want to say get only this first row what
I'll do is I'm gonna take zero and then
right here I'm gonna pick everything so
I'll run it and I'll have one two zero I
have only this right here now if I want
to get this last column what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna specify I wanna get all
the rows and then for the column I want
to get the last column so there we go I
have the last column zero negative one
because I'm I'm turning from the end
actually here now another way you could
do this is by saying okay I have zero
one two so I'll take the second index
run that and I should have the same
answer so that's it now if I want to go
from zero to two so I'm gonna pick
there's a two means I'm picking zero and
one so I'm picking this two actually
picking this two around that see I have
zero zero negative one two all right I
have zero negative one zero two the
reason why I have this is because right
here I have the zero negative one and
then yeah I have zero two so that's it
the zero negative one is because I've
picked or I've picked these two indices
so zero negative one is the last right
here the last index or the last column
pick out the last column and then for
this I also pick out its own last column
so that's how this works we just have
those Commerce which separates this now
another way I could do this is I could
take all so doing all I should have
exactly the same response so instead of
having that I could just put out there's
three dots right here
then Euro could pick out all so yeah I'm
supposed not taking all this since we're
picking up all this indices that's what
we're picking up one two three four all
these four elements we're picking up for
each of these elements or the rows
making this all the rows and then for
each of these we also pick up just the
second column so if we here we're
picking up all those rows and just a
second columns then we'll be left with
zero for this and negative one then for
this we left with zero two this zero
zero there's nine thirty two
we now move on to tensorflow.math which
you could see clearly here
we'll be able to use others matte
functions
which only available with tensorflow so
as you could see we go right up to this
zero function so starting from the
apps function this apps here clicking on
it would have tf. method apps and note
that for each and every function you
have the function definition and you
will have an explanation so like you
have this kind of example where the
function has been applied and you'll be
able to understand exactly how the
functions are used so in case you want
to understand how the A10 to function
works just click on that you have this
we click on a sign actually let's oh
let's just work with Esa in case we want
to work with the a sign you would have
this you have this example and then you
get this explanation on all these
arguments which get into this function
like the X you have the name and then
what it actually returns so you don't
need to always figure out by yourself
how this functions work it just
basically need to make good use of this
documentation
now that's it let's look at a couple of
functions we have the apps function it's
actually the absolute value so it gives
the absolute value of a tensor now to
get the absolute value
we simply pass in the tensor so like in
this case where we Define this x so X
apps we have the X which is this tensor
right here and then we could get it
after the value very easily so we have
that we run it and you see we have the
absolute value now what's an absolute
value up to the values are defined as
such if the number or the input is a
negative so if the input is negative it
says it
to positive so it turns into positive if
the input is a positive it turns it into
uh positive so it Remains the Same or
basically here Remains the Same so that
said we could say for example TF dot
apps of say
TF that constant 0.2 if you run that
you'll see you still have the same now
if we tend this to negative 0.2 you
would have still 0.2 so it takes it from
a negative number to a positive number
or basically
we can say that the absolute value of x
is negative X when X is less than zero
and this equals x when X is greater than
zero so if we have a positive number it
Remains the Same and if we have a
negative number you attach a negative
sign and obviously a negative with a
negative would turn this to a positive
so that's why when you have this
negative 0.2 here you have negative of
negative 0.2 it turns into 0.2 so that's
it for the absolute value function
you could also check out when we have
the complex number that is if a tensor
if we have a complex tensor you could
check out this absolute value function
right here the inputs of this absolute
value function can also be complex
numbers now
if we have a complex number say A Plus
BG then its absolute value is computed
as a squared plus b squared all of that
square root so if we have negative 2.25
plus 4.75 J as you see it looks exactly
the same as a plus b j right here then
we'll have the absolute value or get
absolute value by doing negative 2.25
square plus or rather the square root of
negative 2.25 square plus 4.75 Square
that said let's take this off let's just
have one so if we have just this one
right here okay now we run this x apps
X apps complex
complex and then yeah we have X apps
complex two
complex
okay so let's run this and you get this
output 5.25 now let's do
a squared us let's take this if we have
the square root we'll be using the
square root method so we have T at the
square root of negative
3.25 Square notice how the this pops up
right here with the definition nice with
the documentation of the square root
method so we have the square root text
in this input and then name so basically
we're just finding the square root of
all the elements we have in our tensor
so that's it we have negative 2.25 plus
4.75 Square so 4.75 Square so that's it
we complete the square root and we see
that
we do not have the same answer that's
because we didn't put this in the
bracket so there we go we run this again
and we see we have exactly the same
answer so we're now check on the
addition so yeah we look at this
addition function this can be seen as
element wise addition so supposedly we
have X1
and then X2
TF dot constant
we have
C7
6 2 6 7 and 11. the type specified z
type CF dot ins 32 we could simply do CF
dot add X1
and X2 so let's run this we'll get our
outputs basically the addition of all
this elements so it's an element wise
addition now you could check out other
methods like multiply so you could have
multiply multiply run that C5 times 735
and so on and so forth you could check
out subtract so we could have here
subtract
and you have your answers uh let's check
out divide divide
there we go run that there we go five
divided by seven divided by six and so
on and so forth
then we also have other interesting
methods like this divide no Nan so in
the case where you divide into values
and you expect it to have a nine like
when you dividing by zero is by the
twelve and then that's not a number
this method takes care of that exception
for you
so let's come in here and instead of
zero run that again you see we have this
now let's uh this infinite Infinity so
let's now say no Nan run that
we have this error because this is
actually a math so you should have that
we have here that tenses of type in 32
are not allowed so let's take for
example a float so let's change this we
have float floats
there we go run it again and it's fine
so you see that when you have this like
if you are having a problem where you
just want to have this nands or this
outputs where it's meant to have
Infinity give you a zero then you could
use this method right here
now note that it's not every time that
when we're doing this element wise
operations that we have the two tensors
being of the same shape so that said we
could modify this so let's take this
to be just seven right here let's take
back to add so we have ADD and run this
again you will notice that we were able
to do this addition but with the
difference from the others where the two
tenses had the same shape in that yeah
we have the seven which adds up to each
and every value we have right here so
seven plus five twelve seven plus three
ten and so on and so forth now this is
what we call broadcasting
in broadcasting we have this smaller
tensor which is stretched out to match
the shape of this bigger tensor so that
the operation could be carried out so in
fact what's going on here is you have
this
X2 right here which has been stretched
out so we could see extra stretched
stretched and then what we actually have
is this so finally when we're carrying
out the operation we have this seven
let's make sure we have this values
right seven and then we have this last
seven so this guy this one we have now
let's print this out let's copy this
and then we have X2 stretched that's
that's it now we run it and we see that
we have exactly the same output so in
fact when you put this
tensorflow does broadcast broadcasting
and this uh tensor right here has been
stretched out like this and then the
operation is carried out
so we could test this out with
multiplication let's
modify this supposing we have this right
here we have that
say 5 45 so on and so forth okay so we
have X2 and then we have X1 let's put
out let's still run with the addition
let's take off the shape
around that see gives the same answer we
go to multiplication multiply
multiply there we go run it again we see
we have this element-wise multiplication
now another slightly more complicated
way of looking at this is when we have a
shape or when we have a tensor where one
of the indices has a length of one so if
we take this off let's suppose it will
take let's take this other one off so if
we take this one off right here you see
we have a shape of one by six
now let's define X2 differently let's
take off the X2 stretch from here so
let's define X2 differently we have in
this case instead let's define a three
by one
tensor so would have this
we have 5 we have three so there we go
run that
let's take this one off
uh let's print out the shapes actually
let's print out
X1 dot shape
print out X2 that shape there we go we
have this is X1 1 by 6 x 2 3 by 1 and
then the output of the element wise
multiplication is this Matrix we have
here so now let's explain how we get
this Matrix yeah if we rewrite this
tensor right here would have this it has
this one row so we have one row and then
six columns as you can see here and then
this other where we have three rows and
one column this is one column three rows
one two three now that said when we want
to carry out the operation your
we've taken to consideration the fact
that we have three rows right here so
what goes on is this
one row is stretched out so you stretch
out such that we now have three rows to
match up with these three rows we have
in this X2 so that said we have now five
three
and finally six right here so there we
go we now have this new
tensor that's it and then for this you
should guess it right we are gonna
stretch this out such that the number of
columns match with the number of columns
of this so basically
we're just gonna rewrite this six times
there we go three right yeah what we're
reading this six times we'll stretch
this out and now we could carry out our
multiplication operation so let's take
for example this element we have the six
times five right here we should have 30
so that's why we have 30 here and if we
take four times five twenty that's why
you have 20 year if you take this four
by three that's why we have 12 right
here
so we have that
as a rule of thumb but should have one
dimension of length one as you could see
here
and then the other dimensions are
stretched so as to match one another
our next method will be the TF the
maximum method so there we go we have TF
dot maximum
which gives us the max of two tenses
or better set the element wise maximum
of two tenses now this should be the
same with the minimum which Returns the
element wise mean of two tenses so that
said if we have this two tenses X and Y
you see that we're going to have here
negative five so negative five zero
negative two the mean is negative two
negative two zero zero I mean zero zero
three means zero so that's it
as you could see here this surpass the
broadcast semantics that the
broadcasting we've just seen so that's
it for the maximum and minimum we also
have the
AG Max and the arc mean which you're
gonna see shortly so let's go we have
the ACT Max
okay that's it now with the AG Max is a
slightly different syntax yeah we have
an input and then we specify the axis
so let's copy this B right here let's
copy this
tensor
phases out there we go
okay we have this B oh we have this egg
egg Arc uh X Arc Max for example so we
have this tensor let's rewrite this we
have this tensor here and then we let's
print out X Arc Max that shape we know
the shape
okay now we want to get the arc Max
but before looking at the arc Max of
this
tensor let's look at the simpler tensor
so let's take something simpler let's
have this
um let's say we have yeah let's close
this okay so we have this and let's
print out X our Max
we have TF tm.mat dot Arc Max of this
and then we have that oh we have it okay
so let's run that we see that we have a
value of two now why do we have this
value of two
why do we like with this metrics given
to us have this through here now what if
we modify some of these values say let's
take this to be 200 let's take this to
be 120 stay 130 and 0 3 run it again oh
we have this run that again we see that
now this value changes to zero why does
it change to zero now if you notice
previously like let's copy this again
let's press this out here let's take now
this all this take this or that okay
you'll notice that with this
the position of the maximum value is the
zeroth index now
if we have here this is our zeroth Index
this is uh
first Index this is our second index
your third
and then your foot
so where is the maximum value here you
guessed it right is 200 where does it
fall zeroth index and so the output is
zero let's take this as an example where
does the maximum value fall it falls
here where's the index zero
one two three and that's why we have
this so actually the arc Max is
different from a Max in the sense that
yeah we're actually looking for the
index or the position of the maximum
value
so that's it
if you want to have the mean we just
have to change this to mean so we could
have mean run that you'll see we should
get this year so we have zero one two
three that's it there's a minimum value
this position is the third position now
if we change this to mean two we have
that we should have this last position
zero one two three four so that's it
now when we did it with
multi-dimensional tenses like this one
right here we can specify an axis so
let's do this we have we print out TF
dot matte dot Arc Max of x marks or X
Arc Max and that will specify the zeroth
axis now we'll look at the output and
we'll explain why we will have the
output so here we have two two zero two
two now let's understand why we have
this output given to us
notice that right here we have fixed the
axis to zero and so that said
we are actually fixing the rows
so we have a row we have these three
rows or let's take this we have this one
row we have this row and then we have
this row and then we're doing
comparisons on the uh each element or
the
corresponding elements
on each row so it turns out now to be
the column so here we compare this two
that's on this row we compare this two
with this three with this 14 and then
yeah we compare this
here we compare this let's take that off
yeah we compare this three one five
yeah we compare 6 8 27 so that's it so
when you fix the access to zero it
simply means
comparison is done on the other axis so
in this case that other axis is a column
so we're doing comparisons on each and
every column now what is the maximum
value here the maximum value is 14.
where does it fall in this uh in the
tensor if we have the tensor 2 3 14 we
see clearly is positioned if the axis we
have the zero position first position
second position so we see that it falls
on the second position that's why here
you have this two now if you look at
this our maximum is This falls in the
second position that's why you have two
we continue to this our maximum year is
30 force on the zeroth position
um if you want to look at it clearly we
have 30 extract that we have 30 16 and
23 our maximum Falls here
the zeroth index 0 1 2 so that's why you
have zero and then for the next you have
five and then here we have 27 that's why
we have this 2 2 0 2 2. now let's take
this off and then
um change this to mean so change that to
mean so we have a different answer we
have here zero our minimum is this next
is one our minimum is this next our
minimum is this one minimum is this one
next we have this okay so that's it now
let's modify this axis so we change the
axis now we will be working on each row
so we'll be doing comparisons on this
row comparisons on this and then
comparison this
so if you've understood what we've seen
previously when access was equals zero
and we had axis equals zero then you
should be able to pause at this point
and then try to solve that for when it
axis equals one so that said let's
explain how this works we're gonna have
comparisons with this so the maximum
years or the minimum since we'll change
this to mean our minimum year will be
two your minimum is
one your minimum is five so that said
we're gonna have zero since our axis
position is zero or we're on the Zero
index and then here we add the
zero one two three three and then yeah
we have zero one two three so we're
gonna have zero three three so let's
take that off run it
and we have zero three three as expected
you have other functions right here
um we have the equal function which
could be used to compare tenses so we
could compare two tenses
and in a case where our each and every
element is the same we're going to have
this output Boolean tensor so you see
the type Bull and then here we have true
true the reason why we have true true
here is because this element 2 is the
same as this and the F4 it's a must four
now we see again broadcasting here where
we have two four compared with two two
now if you have a two it's broadcasted
to match the shape so we this two turns
into two two now the first two Compares
with this two is true and the next two
Compares will be false is not with four
it's not the same so it turns into false
so that's how we look at this we have
the documentation here we could look at
other methods we have this
power meter right yeah
we have
um
yeah we have the power method yeah we
basically to get the power or to raise
all these elements were given power
let's copy this so we better understand
that
this is all right yeah scroll down okay
so we have this x we have the Y and then
let's understand this power now
basically what you understand here is
let's reduce this to c0 and then year
one okay so as we're saying
stick so forth social activity one there
so while we have here is we're taking 2
to the power of three
future power zero three to above one
three triple four so if we run this this
off when this you see clearly we have
two to the power of three is eight two
to the power zero is one three to the
power one three three zero four eighty
one so that's how it works now we could
have t of the power sorry power and then
TF dot constant of C2 and then TF dot
constant
constant of say three so we have that
run it there we go we have eight
on next we will reduce reduces we have
here the reduce all reduce any reduce
your TDN reduce Max mean uh prod STD
some variance let's start with the
reduced sum which is kind of like the
most popular of all this so we have the
reduced sum uh what goes in here is it
computes it takes in the input tensor
axis keep the keep Dimension set to
false by default name none so it
compares the sum of elements across
dimensions of a tensor so again here
we're specifying the axis and we're
going to sum to the all the elements in
that axis so let's look at some examples
business out right here so we have this
uh input tensor let's copy let's say we
have let's work with one of the tensors
we had declared previously so let's have
this tensor 2D right here we have tensor
2D
um we have it here
okay tensor 2D there we go
um now we want to print this out print
of this
we have that and then in here we have
our tensor to the tensor to the there we
go we specify the axis uh let's let's
first run this and see what gives us
this output
so we told we have an error oh we didn't
close this run that again
okay so we have this here first of all
this is this
um
2D you upgraded in the now let's run
this okay so now we have this value of
35 how do we have this value of 35 when
you don't specify the axis what goes on
yours we just add up all elements so we
begin with uh our elements I will reduce
the tensor and then the production is
done by summing all the elements which
make up this tensor 1 plus 2 plus 0 is 3
3 6 11 10 11 16 plus 6 uh 22 24 27 and
35 so that's how we get all this all
right that's how we get this by summing
up all this so this will reduce some uh
that said we could do a reduce Max so
reduce Max
there we go we have eight so what goes
on here is we're reducing all these
values
into just its maximum value so we see
with the sum we're adding up everything
with a Max we're just looking at the
maximum value so if you change this to
let's say we take this to 100 you see
you get our 100. now if we look at
reduced mean you run that it should have
zero so that's it let's take negative
here run it
okay we have negative two so that's it
now let's go back to our reduced sum and
then let's specify the axis let's say
the axis is zero
let's bring back the shape of this
tensor to the tensor 2D that shape let's
run that so we get a shape okay it's
four by three now let's okay we'll
specify the x is zero now we have 7 11
40 or 114 now why do we have this
specifying those axis zero means we're
fixing the axis are we like taking a
fixed position on this axis zero and
then we're playing around with the other
axis which is the axis one and which
happens with the column because we have
the rows axis zero and then we have the
columns axis one so what goes on here is
we're now doing this we comparing all
right I will summing up we're reducing
this into one we reduce this
and then we reduce this
so one plus three plus one that's five
plus two seven so that's how we have
this negative two plus all of that
eleven if you add all of this you have
140 and so that's how we get this by
when we fix this axis to zero now let's
fix the axis to one you'll see that we
fix the columns and we paint around with
the rows so here we compare this all
right I will sum this up uh summing this
up we have negative one this should be a
hundred and eight this should be 12 and
so on and so forth so let's run it and
we see that we have negative 108
12 13 and that's it so that's how we
look at this now we could go back to Max
reduce Max
that's it we could go to reduce mean
C 0 36 for 14. now the means like the
average value so let's take this Axis or
let's let's hit the X zero run it and we
have that now what's the mean of this
when comparing this we have one plus
three four plus one five plus two seven
seven divided by
four
is 1.75 but since we're dealing with
integers we just have one so let's
change this D type let's say we want to
have a d type of TF the float 16 so we
run that and there we go we have 1.75 so
that's it we just calculating the mean
of each uh on each of these columns
because we've fixed uh We've set a tool
fix the rows and then we paint around
with each and every column now we could
change this to standard deviation
standard deviation we have that
0.829 2.86 41.38
so that said we now look at the keep
dreams now take another look at this
shape right here we just have this one
dimension tensor here now when we do
this two when we send this to true we
run that we see that this turns into a
two-dimensional tensor with the same
elements but we've added this extra Axis
or this extra Dimension right here
and you could actually get to see this
explanation from this so that's it we've
looked at the reduces or you reduce Max
I mean STD prod variance and all of that
now we continue our journey through our
math functions we have this sigmoid
which is one of the very popular method
the sigmoid we're going to see this uh
is basically this formula is basically
this function so y equals uh it takes in
X and then what it does it takes the
exponential of negative x 1 plus
exponential and then one divided by one
plus exponential so basically this is
this function and then when we run the
sigma we just take each and every
element and then pass into this function
our next method will be the stop K matte
function with the top key uh what we're
doing here is we're taking uh as input
our tensor and then we're taking the top
uh the top say if k equals two we're
taking the top two values just like in
the class of 100 students and then you
want to get the top 10 students oh it's
kind of like the same function so that's
it we have that
um let's
see how that works in a notebook so yeah
we have
top key around a TF the matte dot k and
let's just take in this tensor 2D right
here so we have the stencil 2D we run
that
and get this output note that this
output comes out oh we two values so we
have first of all
this first part of the couple and the
second part of the couple the second
part has to do with it indices that is
the positions of this top K values so by
default as we saw the K is equals one so
by default we have oops by default we
have k equals one so that's what we have
by default so we run that we should have
the same answer so that said let's come
slide this up okay so what we're seeing
here is we going through each and every
row so we're going to each and every row
we look what's the Top Value right here
is one what's this position zero so we
have one year position zero so our value
is a hundred position two so value is
six position two to value is eight
position two so that's how we get these
values now let's say we want to take top
two
top two we see we have um the top two
values one and zero we have their
positions 105 positions six and five
that's it eight and three as you can see
that's it
and by default this is sorted so you
don't need to bother about sorting now
you could change this to false in case
you don't want to do uh you don't want
to have it necessarily sorted
let's now go ahead and look at linear
algebra operations so here we have tf.ly
knock go right here we have TFW knock
and we have all this different linear
algebra operations which come with
tensorflow let's look at the metrics
multiplication giving yours mod so to
have the linar dot Mall
what does it do multiplies a matrix a by
a matrix B producing a times B
now not bad this is different from the
multiply and the TF the mat the
multiplier we had seen previously as the
T of the mat the multiplier was an
element wise multiplication whereas here
we're working with a matrix
multiplication
so like yeah we place this out we have
Tiara mall and then let's go ahead and
Define these two matrices X1 TF dot
constant
and then X2 so we have X2 just recopy
this and then we have that now we have
our X1 X2 and then we want to find the
matrix multiplication of the two
matrices so it will place here X1 and
then we have X2 uh for now we have all
this default values so that's fine now
let's run this and then see what we get
now what do we have we have an arrow
which is normal we've been told that
there is a mismatch now why is there
this mismatch if we check out the shapes
like you know the shapes of X1 and X2 X1
X2 shape you would see that both have
shapes two by three two by three now if
you want to do matrix multiplication
then this is impossible since in order
for matrix multiplication to be valid
the total number of columns we have here
must match the number of rows we have
here so since this number of columns
which is equals three is different from
this number of rows there's not uh it's
not possible for us to carry out the
matrix multiplication operation so that
said let's modify this we have let's now
have a 3 battery dial shaped Matrix so
we'll have this
for that and then we run it
see that works so this works now because
this three the number of columns here
equals number of rows right here now
let's even change this let's let's
increase the number of columns if it
increases number of columns we have
this oh we'll increase the number of
rows by doing this so let's go back
okay let's increase the number of
columns to do that we need to do this so
let's take two let's take zero so let's
run that we see it's still valid because
here we still have this equal this that
is the number of columns here equals
number of rows here so since it matches
we could still work that out now once
you take off so if we take this off you
see running this now we still have the
mismatch because here we have this three
different from one let's take one step
back
we run that
and that's what we have now also note
that the output of this matrix
multiplication
has a shape which is dependent on its
inputs so if you notice the output has a
shape two by four and this two here is
going from this number of rows and then
the Fourier is going from this number of
columns
and that said if now we instead have a
one by three that is if we have one by
three times three by four our output
will be one by four so let's run this
you see you have one by three three by
four I'll put this one by four and
here's what we get
now if you don't voice with this linear
algebra
terminologies you could check on our
linear algebra cost available on our
platform neural land dot AI so you could
check on this yeah you will have this
cars on or the section on Matrix algebra
it would have matrix multiplication
right here and you get to understand all
this in depth so you could check on this
preview
you see how here we explain step by step
with some class exercises how all this
works
another way you could compare the matrix
multiplication of the X1 and X2 is by
having this so we could say TF or rather
we could simply have X
one right here
at X2 so this is matrix multiplication
while this is element wise
multiplication so we have that add run
it and we should have exactly the same
answer we got here so there we go we
have exactly this same answer
another very common metrics
operation is that of the Matrix
transpose so yeah we'll look at how to
do the transpose of a matrix just just
put this dot capital T you run that
another way you could compute the matrix
multiplication of the X1 and X2 is by
simply doing X1 at X2 so we run this you
see we have exactly the same response we
got from here now we move to another
linear algebra operation or Matrix
operation
which is that of the Matrix transpose so
let's compare the Matrix transpose we
just have TF the transpose C of the
transpose and then we pass in our
metrics so we have passed in X1 we run
that you'll notice that the rows becomes
the columns and the
and you'll notice how rows become
columns and columns become rows so let's
uh get back to our X1 let's print out X1
site here X1
there we go we have this X1 right here
we see how
the shape is one by three and that of
the transpose is three by one it still
contains exactly the same numbers but
now this Matrix that's the initial X1
has just one row as you could see one
row whereas you only have three rows
so this
becomes this this two becomes this this
0 becomes this now let's take this now
with
X2 so we run X2 or rather let's let's
print out X2 first so we have X2 right
here now notice how this one two zero
that's this first row one two zero two
becomes our first column this second row
becomes our second column and this third
row five or four five six zero becomes r
chart column so we have a year four five
six zero so this is basically the
transpose of patient now how is that
related to this matrix multiplication
you may have noticed here we have
transpose a false and transpose B false
so in the case you are trying to
multiply uh X1 by say X2 transpose you
just have to put B
true recall that X2 is B so because
initially we had a right here and B
so if we multiply this all right I'll
change this to true now you'll be
multiplying x on by X2
transpose let's run this and we should
have an error this is normal why because
we're multiplying X1 by X2 transpose now
what is X Plus let us let us say we have
TF dot transpose
transpose X2 so that the transpose and
then we get a shape so we run that and
we see that we have one by three times
four by three we see that this 3 is not
equal to four so the number of columns
here is not equals number of rows right
here and so we're gonna do the matrix
multiplication so that's set
that's not valid so let's uh modify this
let's say we take let's create X3 so we
could have X3 which has four columns so
we could have exterior with four columns
let's change this X3
and then yeah let's say we have this
just two okay so we have that we have
that uh we'll print out x three so we
print out X3 shape x3. shape there we go
we run that we have
X1 X2 X3 X4 now notice how uh sorry it
is X2 so this is X2 transpose now
because this is three four three four
ten so four three so it's normal so we
have X3 what we're trying to find here
is X3
at uh X3 Matrix multiplied by X2
transpose so Matrix multiplied by the
transpose of X2 that's it so let's bring
this out
print it out saved as valid so
we have this error TF TF
dot transpose so there we go we see that
we are having an output right here which
is uh two by three that's because this 4
is the same as this four and then our
output will take number of rows two and
then this number of columns here three
so that's it so it kind of like takes
the those outputs this outer
axis that we have here so that said we
have in our transpose
of X2 and then we multiply X3 by e now
how do we have this exact same response
without necessarily having to say for
example LT of the transpose X2 all we
need to do is just specify that our X2
is going to be transposed and here we
have X3 so we have X3 and then X2 so
it's just like we multiply X2 by X2 but
we send out our X2 is going to be
transposed so that's it we run that and
we should have exactly the same response
so that's it we have exactly the same
response is doing this is the same as
saying X3 times or actually metrics
multiplied by X2 transpose so we'll send
transpose B is true now if you send this
to true
this should let's check out what's going
to be turn we are having X3 X3 shape is
2 4. so if we have the transpose of x3
is going to give us 4 2
times the transpose of X2
X2 is actually let's check it actually
three four the transpose is four three
so we have four two by four three it's
not going to work so if you run this
this shouldn't work we're having four
two by four three
now if we change this
because we're having X2
transpose let's say extra transpose is 4
and then x three transpose
is four three so for this to match we
must modify this so if we change X to 3
to a three by two Matrix
let's have that rather Yes actually X3
so this X3 and this X2 so let's modify
X2 so that we have uh
three by two metrics and for modifier X2
to be a three by two Matrix then X2
transpose will be a two by three Matrix
and if we have two right here this
matrix multiplication will match so
let's go ahead and change this into a
three by two Matrix three color three
rows and then two so let's take this off
take this off take this off that's fine
okay so X2 now is three by two and X2
transpose is two by three so this should
match
let's command this out that's fine and
run it
so yeah we have an error okay the error
is coming from the fact that yeah we
need to put a transpose so and this will
have TF that transpose because now we're
doing X3 transpose times X2 transpose so
we're gonna have this
see if the transpose here that's fine so
let's find it now and everything should
work fine see we have exactly the same
response because we actually do an X3
transpose by X2 transpose and this
ships here now match
now the way we look at this next
argument here that the adjoints is
exactly the same as for the transpose
and that join uh I joined in a metrics
is another operation
which will not get into the details
but just not that specifying this or
saying that agent of a is true for
example is the same as just saying we're
taking the adjoint of x3 and multiplying
by X2 if we say
uh if this is false and then year is
true so if we have this then what we're
saying is with multiplying X3 by the
adjoint of X2 so it's the same as or
similar to the way we treat the
transpose arguments right here let's now
look at how to multiply matrices with
greater than two Dimensions so let's go
ahead and take this tensor 3D we had
defined previously we have tensor 3D
right here we just put it out down right
here we have tensor 3D we've now defined
this two three dimension
tenses X1 and then X2 so there we go
we run this and this is what we get so
we have this two three dimension tensors
and we want to do matrix multiplication
so we could simply have TF dot mall or
TF dot linog then you know algebra Mall
we have that and then we specify X1 and
specify X2 running this should produce
an error this is normal again because
there is no matching in the shapes now
how do we look at this now the way we
look at this is quite
straightforward what we'll do is when
having this kinds of matrix
multiplication where matrix
multiplication is done in batches
what we do is look at each and every
batch and look at his corresponding
batch in the other metrics and then do
the matrix multiplication so what we
have here is we're multiplying one this
Matrix here this to the matrix by this
Matrix
now if you have to multiply this Matrix
here by this Matrix
and then later on this matrix by this
Matrix and then this Matrix
by this Matrix then you must make sure
that there's a matching in their shapes
now this Matrix right here is two by
three and this is two by three we've
seen already at two by three multiply
with two by three wouldn't work because
the number of columns here is three and
the number of rows here is two which
don't match so what we need to do now
is we could modify the sensor such that
each of these matrices right here have a
shape which will match with this such
that we could do the matrix
multiplication so let's change this now
into two by two matrices so instead of
this let's take this off take that off
two by two
comma and finally here we have this
camera and that's it so now we have X1
which is two by two and then X
10 which is two by three
two by two two by three will output as
two by two and then two by three will
give us an output which is two by three
so it's going to be two by three output
now let's take that off and then run
this
while we run that we see this output uh
let's take this off let's take this X1
X2 off so we take that off run it again
so we could see clearly our output now
notice how what goes on here is we have
this Matrix multiplied with this
this
with this so on and so forth now if you
want to check this let's go ahead and
recreate this right here so what we're
gonna do now is we're gonna just take
let's take for example this middle
values here off take this off
take this off there we go uh we have
this okay so that's fine so now we have
this
okay we have this two we have this
Matrix that is to the tensor and then
let's take this middle value because we
chose the middles so let's take this
take this off
and then yeah we take this off okay so
we have exponent X2 and then we're
trying to print this out
we'll run this we have 10 20 20 11 8 6.
so taking the middle values if I look at
this carefully you see we have exactly
the same response so this confirms the
fact that while we're doing what we call
batch multiplications where a batch is
considered to be one of this
indexes in the zeroth axis so we have
this zeroth axis right here we have
three indexes so each and every one of
those indexes is considered to be a
batch so when we're doing this kind of
batch multiplications we just take each
and every one and multiply with this
corresponding value in the other metrics
from here we explain why we or how we
use this sparse or this B is parse on
this A's bars arguments that we have
right here now the way this works is
sometimes we have matrices which are
full of zeros so we may have a matrix
like this let's modify this and then
here we have zero
yeah we have a zero yeah we have a zero
and then yeah we could have a zero zero
and that's it so we could have matrices
like this which are made of mostly zeros
and so what happens is tensorflow has a
way of optimizing competitions involving
tensors which are mostly made of zeros
the steps of tenses are known as RS
tensors so when you specify that a
tensor that's called a tensor is parse
tensorflow takes that into consideration
when carrying out the computation and
this helped us
carry out competitions even faster since
tensorflow now knows that this Matrix or
the particular Matrix or a particular
tensor is made of mostly zeros
so that's it we could check on other
methods like the adjoints method which
is spoke of previously since agile metal
right here I'm ready to get the agent of
a matrix very easily
let's now look at the band part method
and this band part method
we actually rewriting the tensor by
setting some values to zero based on
certain conditions so here we have an
input we have a num lower and a num
upper we have the name as usual so right
here we have an input which could be of
K Dimensions as is defined right here
and then we have this conditions
so we have this
indicator function which is say in band
and with its conditions and then we take
this in band and multiply by the input
Matrix right here to finally get the
output so let's look at this example
right here we see that we have this
input we have this which is passed into
the band part method and then we have
this output you'll notice that this
output looks similar to the input but
the difference that at some positions
you have zeros so this negative three
stands to zero negative two ten to zero
and this negative 2 here 10 to 0. so
that's how we look at it uh
before looking at the special cases
let's take an example so we understand
exactly how this works
note that here this indicator function
is defined such that for each and every
element of this
new metrics in band okay we'll create a
new creating a new Matrix in band such
that each and every element
is defined such that if this num lower
num lower is passed in here so if for
example like this num lower if the num
lower is less than zero or M minus n m
minus n happens to be the
position of each element in the Matrix
or on the tensor so if M minus n is less
than num lower less than one and if num
upper is less than zero or n minus m is
less than or equals num upper then this
in band
will be such that when multiplied with
this corresponding element in the input
then that input
Remains the Same but if this condition
is not verified then that input turns to
a zero yeah we have this tensor this to
the tensor which we've defined we have
that condition which was given to us in
the documentation and then what we do is
we're going to Define this two matrices
one is M minus n and the other one is n
minus m
notice how this tool have exactly the
same shape as the input so what's going
on right here what happens here is we
have M first of all you have to
understand that M is for the rows and
then n for the columns so what goes on
here is we have at this position we have
the zero row zeroth column so M minus n
that's 0 minus zero is equal to zero at
this position we are at the zeroth row
and the first we are not allowed to zero
minus mod one time so once this position
zero row minus Second Color zero minus
eight and we have hours position so we
have the row zero negative zero let's
color one two zero zero one oh yeah nine
second row all right we are the all
first row indices
and first just row
second column one minus two negative one
and then we continue with this and we
get all these values so this is how we
get M minus n we're simply taking the
index uh
the row index minus the column index
now we look at n minus M for n minus M
we're looking at the column index minus
the row index so yeah we add the zeroth
row zero column zero minus zero zero
here we add the
First Column and the zeroed row so one
minus zero is one here we add the second
column and the zeroth row so two minus
zero is two so that's how we get this
um n minus M Matrix right here now once
we've got an M minus n Matrix and N
minus M Matrix
we can now see how to get the output
very easily so we have this output for
now if we place it by this axis and
we're gonna get all each and every
element it's exact value after going to
this band part method right here
since we have us input our lower to be
zero and our upper to be zero we could
take this condition off because our
lower will never be less than zero so we
could take that off so we could have
this out there we go and now we'll be
focusing on M minus n so at this
position M minus n which is 0 is
actually less than or equal it's
actually equal the lower since our lower
is zero and our upper is zero so we have
M minus n here is it it's actually less
than or equals or lower
so we have that to be true and then n
minus M which is 0
is actually
less than or equals our upper since our
upper is zero so that's true so since
all this is true we have these
value at this position that's the zero
row zero column position that's when m
equals zero this is where m equals zero
and n equals zero so at this position
where m equals zero and n equals zero
this is going to be maintained so this
one is going to be maintained so that's
how it gets output maintained Now we
move to this next one year so in this
next we have an m to be equals 0 and
then n moves to one while the first
column we come again and check your M
minus n we have a negative one negative
one is it less than or equals or lower
because that's true it's less than or
equal to zero and then
uh n minus m
n is 1 m is zero that is one is one less
than or equals upper no that's not true
one is not less than or equals zero so
this condition is not fulfilled since
this is not true so both must be true so
since this is not true this value this
negative two is ten to a zero so here we
have a zero now we'll move to the next
we do the same uh yeah we have a zero
now what shall is uh we're always going
to have a zero because if the zero is
maintained we have a zero if we turn to
a zero it should have a zero so no need
chicken on this now we go to the next we
have to read for this we are at m equals
plus m equals one and then n equals two
no any calls yeah we m equals one and
then n equals zero sorry so we have n
equals zero now we have n equals zero we
could compute this m minus n one minus
zero is one but one is not less than
zero or it's not less than or equal to
zero so this is not true so this three
turns to a zero so here we will have a
zero that's how we get the zero right
here now we go to this five we have m
equals one and n equals one in this case
M minus n is equal to zero Which is less
than or equals zero so that's this is
true this year is true and then n minus
m is zero this is also true so we
maintain this value so this tends to a
five when it will get this we have m
equals one in this case and then n
equals two so we have one right here and
then we have two okay M minus n we have
one minus two negative two negative two
is actually less than zero so this is
valid and then yeah we have n minus M
two minus one one is not less than zero
so this is not valid that set since this
is not valid this 100 turns to a zero
so that's it you could just repeat this
and what you should have will be
something like this so yeah you should
have zero and then your you should
maintain its value
and yeah you have eight here you have
three and then here you have two so
that's how you get this oh yeah you
should have a zero actually this is zero
yeah zero now everywhere if you notice
everywhere m is different from n you
will never
uh you will never have a situation where
m is even from n and then m is less than
equal to zero and at the same time n
minus m is less than equals zero so
that's why all the other values of zero
except for this diagonal values so you
see here one five six are maintained
now let's test this so with this command
that and then we run this so there we go
there's a response we get
this comes to confirm what was said here
where the
give this useful special cases and we'll
tell that whenever we have this zero
zero that's graphing input with zero
zero the output is going to be a
diagonal matrix so our diagonal tensor
so right here we understand why we
should have that diagonal now if we
repeat the same process you should be
able to see that zero negative one we
give up a triangular and the negative
one zero will give the lower triangular
now let's go ahead and see what this
upper and lower triangular tensors mean
so yeah let's take this to negative one
we run that and what do we notice we
notice that this Matrix or the input
that stands out to D does it here is
actually maintained so one three one two
see everything's maintained except for
the upper part
now if you have a matrix like this
and that you have this diagonal and then
all this this is what we call the lower
triangle of path of the Matrix and this
is the upper triangular part of the
Matrix so as you could see here this
upper triangular part of this Matrix is
all zeros
and then if we take this to zero so we
have zero negative one if you have zero
negative one and you run that you'll
notice now that it's instead the lower
triangular part so here we have this
lower triangular part
this lower triangle of power right here
which is now made of all zeros so that
said in case you want to get this lower
triangular you just have to specify zero
negative one upper triangular you have
negative one zero and then when I want
to have a diagonal matrix you just need
to specify zero on both sides that's it
for this band part method we look at
other methods we have cholest key
decomposition so here we have a way of
decomposing matrices we wouldn't get
into that
um yeah we have the cross product this
is completely pairwise cost product
cross product of A and B so yeah you
could complete a cross product of two
importances yeah you could get a
determinant of a tensor so you have an
input you could get this determinant
we have many other interesting methods
here we have the inverse
linux.if
we have your tf.linag.if tensor 2D we
run this we should have an error so
that's normal so this is normal because
to obtain the inverse of a matrix that
Matrix
must be a square Matrix that is the
number of rows must be equal to number
of columns so that said let's recopy
this
and then put it here we have
we will Define this tensor to D take
this off that's it and then we now run
this again
we told you we're going to find device
for node
and we given a set of data types which
are registered for the operation Matrix
inverse so this means most probably our
data type isn't
registered in this Matrix inverse
operation now we could search on stack
overflow
we click on this
what we get here I think your value
should be flowed as error says I have
encountered the same problem while
finding the determinant of a matrix and
change the D type to flow 32 and the
problem is solved
so here we have a great way of taking
for this kind of errors but nonetheless
we understood already that this should
most probably come from the data type
we're working with so let's change this
to flow 32 as it was set by the second
workflow user and we have now this other
Arrow which corresponds to the error we
expected so here we are getting this
um error and we told that
let's take this off we told that uh four
different from three now this is normal
because as we said the number of rows
must be equal the number of columns for
us to find
or calculate the inverse of that Matrix
or the tensor so that said what we're
going to do here is if we take this off
and create a three by three Matrix
what we have now will be the right
answer so we see we found the inverse of
this Matrix and this inverse so let's
let's put this in a variable as a tensor
to the inverse
so this inverse is such that when you
multiply so let's run this when you
multiply tensor
now when you do matrix multiplication on
actual not an element multiplication
another element-wise multiplication why
do a matrix multiplication of this two
you should obtain the iron symmetrics so
here you have tensor 2D inverse around
that and you see that you have the
identity Matrix so here you have one
zero zero this is zero very small number
one zero this is zero zero one so here
we have the identity Matrix
taken even in the commentation you see
that we're given a list of
accepted data types and the fluid 16
which we were using previously wasn't a
monk so you have to ensure the input
data types are
in this list
we have this Matrix transpose here
similar to the T of the transpose we
have seen already so that's a transpose
we'll see the Matrix mall that's it we
have the trace we have the singular
value decomposition of a matrix so yeah
you could obtain the matrices singular
value decomposition
this returns three outputs s u and v
where s is a tensor of singular values U
tensor of left singular vectors V in
terms of right singular Vector so the
SVD is a way of breaking up a matrix
in a way that less important information
contained in a matrix is
eliminated so that said we could check
this out right right here we have SVD
taking the tensor so we could simply
just pass in SVD and then get the
outputs
so here we have SVD of tensor
to the SVD of cancer 2D
there we go
um as we did not defined
tf.linear dot SVD we run that and then
we get this output so we have this three
outputs now let's define this s u b
equals that and then let's print out s
so print out s first to see the singular
values so there we go we have the
singular values we print out U we have
uh
tensor of left singular vectors and then
we paint out V
to give us a tense of right singular
Vector so this is what we get right here
so feel free to always look at this
documentation
and when Mario uses methods
the less time you would even need to
always come back to the documentation so
just
make sure you keep practicing so
you'll get to master all those methods
we now go ahead and look at the tf.ansom
method in tensorflow you could have it
as tf.ansom you could look at this
documentation right here with some
examples before diving deep into
understanding how the separator works
it's important to know that this
operator uses or takes in
arrays of all sorts of Dimensions that
is when they arrays to the arrays up to
end the arrays
so we'll start straight up with this
example with two-dimensional arrays I
will see how the enzyme operator can be
used to release the usual matrix
multiplication my Matrix here will
simply meaning a 2d array
and this example will suppose that we
have this array a and then this other
array B
's of dimension of shape three by four B
of shape four by five in order for the
matrix multiplication to be valid we
have to ensure that the number of
columns of a have to be exactly the same
as the number of rows of B
in that case we have to ensure that in
generality this J has to be the same as
this right here
and that's the case for this example and
so the matrix multiplication of A and B
is valid and multiplying this with this
would give us C
but also note that the shape of C
depends on that of A and B
as you could see here if we kind of
merge these two shapes and then take off
this same shapes that's this colon for
the first Matrix and then this Row for
the second Matrix we would have three by
five so look at this auto values right
here this three and this five and that's
what gives us the shape of the output
Matrix C
in general if we have i j j k then we
should have an output I key
so that's how we have this right here
it's very important for you to take note
of the ships whenever you're working
with the handsome operator
okay that's understood let's now dive
into the code let's start by importing
on Pius and B we have that and then we
have this two matrices A and B which
we've defined already so let's command
this for now we have the Matrix a which
is on the slides and we have the Matrix
b as you could see printing out this
will give us a that shape and I will
print out b shape so we have Ada shape
shape gives us three four and then four
five so three by four Matrix and then a
four by five metrics right here as B
and that's it now let's
look for the or let's find the matrix
multiplication of A and B know that in
numpy just suffice to have mp.m mall so
this matrix multiplication which has an
A and then B so there we go we run that
and we'll find this is the answer we get
which is correct this is our C so we've
got an RC now how can we replace this
Matrix small application where the N sum
operation
in order to do that you just take note
of this
syntax right here notice how we have
first of all this
screen right here so we have the string
and what do we put in a string first we
have this IG and then next we will
follow this IG after the IJ we have a
comma and then we have the J key and
then we have this Arrow to ik now this
is going to be read as a
interacting with B to produce C
and the way we're chosen this i j JK
such that it matches up with the shapes
of A and B and what a kind of operation
we're dealing with given that with a
matrix multiplication we have a so
suppose it's i j and then if we have a b
then we must ensure that the J we had
here has to be the same as a j we have
here so this is just like the row so
either row J the column and yeah the row
and then you have the color so we have
to make sure that the number of columns
equal number of rows that's why you have
this J and J right here
and then since the output is such that
it takes the the shape of the output is
I k
that's what we specifying here so we've
taken a b and then transformed into a c
now whatever you have before this
transformation has to be passed
obviously so that's why we have this i j
so the comma here tells us that we have
this i j
matching out with a and then this J K
much as I would be so it's kind of like
separated to different arrays to be
passed and then we have this IC which is
output we get that's why when we paint
this out now we're going to have an
output so this ik is the output we see
clearly that this gives the same answer
as just doing the matrix multiplication
well at this point you will be
downloading like why do I need to do all
this when I could just simply put in the
metric small application or np.m Mall a
b and then I have my answer well that's
a very common and normal question and if
you follow to the end you'll see that in
some examples or in many applications
you'll find that working with the aim
some operator is gonna be easier than
working with the usual numpy functions
or methods you're used to working with
so let's go ahead we've had that I will
now understand the enzyme syntax let's
go ahead and look at many other examples
for our next example will be using the
ancient operator to do an element-wise
multiplication let's take this example
right here we have a that's this Matrix
a we have this Matrix B obviously for l
and y l m n y's modification we have to
ensure that
the two matrices A and B have the same
shape so as you could see from this
we're gonna a shape and b shape we have
three by four and then three by four
let's command this for now
so we have this two right here
three by four three by four let's go
ahead and compute the element wise
multiplication the harlemen how to mount
multiplication we have that there we go
we see that we have two times two gives
us four six times nine 54 and so on and
so forth so just simply
each element on this position
multiplying with its corresponding are
the corresponding element on the other
Matrix like if you just click on this
rundown we have four times five twenty
so that's the output here now in this
case you see that if we have um this
Matrix area of shape ID then B has to be
of shape i g and then the output has to
be of shape i j and so that's why you
would see let's recommend this part
right here you'll see that we have this
input i j
are the first input i j which is a the
second input i j
and then the output IG so the asym
operator automatically seizes as a
harlemen operation so you're gonna have
the right output on that
oh let's take this off
and that's it so there we go we see that
we have the same output as with the
usual high amount operation or the usual
element-wise multiplication
for our next we go on to Matrix
transpose so at this point I'll urge you
to like take a pause try to
come up with a corresponding Matrix
uh the corresponding and some operation
for the Matrix transpose before
continuing with the video
now hopefully you got it right you have
this Matrix a right here which is to be
transposed you see we have two to one
six negative two five and so on and so
forth so basically we have a matrix
which is I of shape i j and it has an up
or j i in this case would have say print
the and some transpose of a
this equals
the prince of mp.m sum
we have that amp the asym of i j
which is being transformed to GI and
then we pass in The Matrix a so let's
take this off right here
and then run that
there we go we have exactly the same
answer so yeah we pass an a we have this
i j no need for any Commerce that's if
you have to multiply let's say we have a
b c d
so on and so forth then you have say i j
j k
l l m yeah we have four right here and
does it so now we have just one so we
have that let's take this off again
that's fine
so hopefully you had this correct
we now move on to working with
three-dimensional arrays
and machine learning is very common to
have to deal with these types of our
race let's suppose we have this array a
which is a 3D array of shape three two
by three by four now let's see the way
we can read this we have this whole
array here e and then we have this two
boxes in uh there's two arrays this one
and then this one so that's where we
have this two Dimension right here and
now for each of these that's for each of
this
arrays we have uh 2D array in it that's
for the first one that's for this first
box right here we have this 2D array
which is of shape can be that's one two
three by four and so that's why we have
uh two and then my three
by four so all those a is a
three-dimensional array of shape two by
three by four okay generalize this as b
i by J and then for B we have uh two by
four by five
dimensional array now note that we have
here that those B's could be taken as a
batch size and this is because in
general or
many times in machine learning
computations are done on batches of data
so in this case we could have this as a
single batch that's this box right here
as a single batch and then we have this
other one as another batch giving us two
batches so we have the batch size equal
to
and then women want to do matrix
multiplication or batch matrix
multiplication where one modified this
Matrix right here of the studio array
with this one and then get this
corresponding output and then multiply
this one with this one and then get this
other corresponding output now we may
not want to say use a for Loop to say
for each of this we multiply this level
this you get output and so on and so
forth we may just want to use
a single operation which understands
that this multiplication is done for
every position in the batch
also note that in these kinds of
computations the batch Dimension remains
exactly the same we have here two two
two while three four multiplied with
four five gives three five so we still
have this exact same
value of B which is maintained
everywhere
now that's set let's go straight away
into the coding we have this 3D array a
right here out of this two
to the arrays the sort of one this one
and then this other to the array we
could come in this part and then
and then we have to print out here that
shape and then be that shape
there we go
oh print
that's fine so two by three by four two
by four by five now note that the matrix
multiplication can parameters do this
without any problems that is we could
get the or we could do the batch
multiplications
with the numpy matrix multiplication as
numpy's matrix multiplication
understands that when data is placed in
batches like this all we need to do is
to ensure that each element in the batch
multiplies the corresponding element in
the batch in the outer array
now if we want to use this we could also
use the in some operator now the way we
use the in some operator here is by
again specifying the shapes so we have
the IJ for a and then we have b j k for
B and then for C we still have b i k
notice how we have i j j k and I K while
B Remains the Same so with this run this
and we'll see that we have exactly the
same answer for the two outputs that
when we use the Matrix small application
and we'll use the asym operator
and still up to this point we see that
we could always or we may not
necessarily use the answer operator
now what if we want to sum up all the
elements in a given array so yeah we'll
look at another different way of
applying or making use of the same
operator so here we have this Matrix or
rather we have this 3D array a right
here and then we want to sum up all the
values in that array here we have the
sum
it gives us a value of 72 and if we want
to use the in some operator what we'll
be doing is we have the ships that's big
we put an arrow and then when you don't
have any output what you're simply doing
is you're summing up all the different
possible values so that's what this
signifies right here so it's just like
saying we're summing up all the possible
values that we put in I will make sure
we have the right shape of a put right
here notice that if we do this you see
we have an error
so we'll correct that we have G run
there and that's fine
we could also sum up all elements in a
given uh Dimension or given row given
column say we're working with the Matrix
here we're having this In Sum let's just
recommend this
uh that's it uncomment this let's
command this part okay so yeah we see
that we have this Matrix a
shape i j and now when we specify only
one of this axis right here what we're
doing is we're summing up
all the elements in each column because
the J is like the column so this is a
row and then this is the column so we're
summing up all the elements in each
column and that's how we have this we
see we have two for the First Column we
have two plus two plus one five six plus
minus two plus five nine five plus two
plus four eleven two plus three equals
zero five so that's how we have that so
the way we understand this is we just
summing up all the elements in each
column and then if we change this to I
we summon up all the elements in each
row around that you see that for this
row we sum this we sum this and then we
sum that
now moving to a more practical example
and those attention is all you need
paper you'll have yeah this formula
right here where we have the query
multiplied with the transpose of a key
if this key has a shape of by size by
sequence length of the key by model size
and the query shape by size by sequence
of the query by a model size then
we could Define this non-pierre query of
shape 32 by 64 by 512 and key 32 by 128
by 512 and then what we'll do now is
Define the
query by transpose operation where would
have empty the N sum of
this is considered to be say bead by
size by Q by m and then this is
considered to say B by K by m so yeah we
would have B q m comma b k m which
outputs B
now at this point we have to very
careful we have qm times km transpose so
this becomes uh BQ M times b m k and I
want to multiply this Q M and M K what
you have is qk so here you have B Q okay
let's take it over again we have b q m
and b k m the base Dimension doesn't
matter take that off so we have this now
and then when we transpose this we have
M K I'm going to multiply this we'll
left with cure K so that's how we have
that and then here we have as input QR
and then K so let's run this
and there we go we have this output
which is of shape we could verify and
shape which is of shape qrk we have here
cure which is 64 by K
which is 128 so we have uh 32 by 64 by
128 output right here
our next and final example will be
inspired from the reformer paper
in this paper the others explain how the
data could be breaking up into chunks
and then the attend to each other again
you don't need to understand what's
going on that paper but it's just for
you to get an idea of where this Robin
while represent comes from
now supposing we have this Matrix a of
initial shape two by four by eight or to
keep them simple let's say one by four
by eight so we have about size of one we
have a sequence length of four and a
model size of eight yeah you could see
this one that's the only single batch we
have here then we have four rows and
then eight columns
B2 has a shape one by four by four so we
have four rows and then four columns and
the paper we just saw
they fought a big up this data into
buckets so and so right here we have
four different buckets now we see that
there's a columns are broken up into
separate four by two matrices here we
have the four by two matrices we have
four rows two columns four rows two
columns and so on so forth now the same
is done for B well the difference that
we break this far up that's what break
the four columns up into four by one
matrices where we have four columns and
just all right at four rows and just one
column
in the paper there is a task which
involves taking the transpose of this be
and multiplying by a
and in doing that
we are in fact multiplying the
corresponding batches and the
corresponding buckets
so you see that again here we have some
sort of two fixed dimensions and then we
have this dimension of this Matrix here
which is actually
going to be involved in the
multiplication process
and so if we have a defined as b c i j
or the shape BC i j and b b c i k
multiplying the transpose of b or
getting the transpose of B would give us
b c c b and c fixed and then uh i k
turns to k i
and a is still BC i j now we have k i
times I J giving us KJ so we have b c k
j so if we have this one four four two
by one four four one we have one for one
two
now with the Einstein operator if we
have the a given us this here we have b
c i j and this b c i k
so let's just put it in common so we
have this BC i j b c i k that we had
seen already on the slides run that and
now we're trying to find B transpose by
a so what we're gonna have here is
non-pilot and sum of
b c i k because here we have B transpose
times a so we have BC i k comma b c i j
which is gonna output b c now at this
point we recall that we're gonna have
uh the ik which is going to be
interchanged to give us k i k i times I
J gives us KJ so we're gonna have KJ
just as we had in the slides and then we
pass in B and then passing a so we'll
run that and then look at the shape
that's it so we see that we're able to
compute this very easily with any sum
operator
as compared to the usual map mall where
we have to ensure that The Matrix B is
transposed correctly so here we're going
to have MP that transpose
of B and then we have to ensure that we
have zero one so zero one fixed and then
we have three two because this is why we
do the transposing and then we now
passing E from this so we have that and
then
there we go we still have the same shape
we could take this off
and then run this you see that we have
the same answer for both methods but
this method looks uh clearly is cleaner
than this one
as if we have to go to see
5 or 5D array or just let's say for
example we have six here and then we
have six all we need to do here is to
see for example D so put that D that way
d
and that's fine so let's run this again
see let's put its shape and that's fine
but what this would have to say zero one
two and then we'll have to ensure that
yeah we have four and then here we have
three
for that to work and so this is an
example showing how the insom operator
comes
to make our work clearer and easier to
understand
let's now look at the expand themes
method
with this method we get to add an extra
axis to an input sensor and that extra
axis has a length of 1.
if we suppose we have this tensor for
example tensor 3D then
let's print out the shape
four by two by three now what we could
do is we could add an extra axis such
that this tensor 3D now takes a shape of
one by four by two by three
that said what we do is
tf.expandems and then we pass in tensor
3D tensor 3D that's it and we specify
the axis so the axis specified to be
zero we're gonna have this output shape
so let's run that and then put out the
shape here
so that's it now let's take a simple
example suppose we have x equals TF dot
constant and then we have this right
here two three four five for example we
could print out X the shape
and then we could print out
tf.expandems
of X and it'll specify the axis to be
zero you'll see that we're gonna have
this shape four and then we have this
output let's put this shape right here
we have this output one by four
notice how the stencil leads from a 1D
tensor into a 2d tensor
still we have the same elements but
we've added one extra axis right here
this extra axis would have been added
manually by doing this so if we had done
this would have had that extra axis we
run that you see we have one by four and
now doing the expand themes we have one
by one by four so now we'll learn from
2D to 3D and then if we keep doing this
you see I will leave again from
3D now to 4D so we have one by one by
one by four so that's how we look at the
expand themes method if you want to do
this expansion of this addition of this
extra dimension in a different axis we
could specify that axis let's say the
first axis axis equals one notice how we
live from four to three now to four one
two three so we kind of like
fit in this here let's take this off
kind of like fit in
this year so when you say x is equal to
zero is fitted right here x equals one
is fitted here x is equal to we feed it
here x is equal to three feet a year X
as equals four invalid so that's it
let's take x equals four for example
you see it's not valid you have three
see now you have four by two by three by
one
from here we look at another method
which is like the opposite of this
expandings method here we have the
squeeze method with this crease method
all you have is you're taking this input
specify the axis just like or similar to
the expand thems method but yeah
we instead remove the dimension of size
one from the shape of the tensor
so let's get back to this we are around
this and we had uh let's take this x
squeezed let's define X squeezed sorry X
expanded
X expanded is this
from that we have X expanded uh one by
one by one by four now let's do X
squeeze
I squeezed s equals TF dot squeeze
and then we pass in X expanded so
firstly we are going to specify the axis
to be equal zero and then we print out
our XP so we have X quiz right here x
squeezed open this out and we should
have this one by one by four so one
axis has been taken off let's do this
several times so here we have for I in
range see let's do this twice
copy this paste this out here there we
go exquised exquised so when you start
by squeezing the first time and then we
continue squeezing let's print out X
squeeze here so here we have X squeezed
that's it we run that and we should get
this so there we go we've left from this
for the tensor to this 1D tensor coming
back to this other example where we had
the shape that is we had expanded
such that this extra axis was added on
the last position so yeah what we're
gonna do is
do a tf. squeeze
with an X which is an expand it and then
specify the axis so now we're going to
specify the third axis because we want
to squeeze out this third or last axis
right here now before squeezing out that
last axis let's take uh let's suppose
we're trying to squeeze out this zero
axis you see we cannot squeeze out this
because we expect the dimension
or the length of this to be equals
one before we could squeeze it so that
said if we specify now three
you see that works fine so now we have
four by two by three recall that this
was
X exp that shape was actually four by
two by three by one so squeezing out now
wait this works now because we'll
specify the right Axis which is of
length one
so that said we've looked at a squeeze
and the expand themes methods which have
to do with modifying or reshaping
tensors let's look at the reshape method
so here we have our reshape method as
usual we have the definition the reshape
the tensor and then we have some
examples so right here we'll see how
we're modifying or reshaping this two by
two tensor into a 1D tensor before
looking at an example let's take a look
at how we could use the TF to reshape to
have the reshape to modify the shape of
this x expanded that is this x which
reduces the shape such that we have an
output of four by two by three so there
we go we have this we pass an X expanded
and then we specify the shape we want to
get as output or the new shape of our
tensor so here we specify four by two by
three we don't want to get a tensor so
let's put that shape even here let's
take this shape we run that
and this is what we get we see that we
have exactly the same output shape right
here now let's change this
remove this and then we compare this to
tensors and we see we have exactly the
same outputs so this tells us that while
we do we deal with the squeezing could
be possibly done with the reshaping now
let's take another example supposing we
have this tensor X shape we could
actually reshape this as we could have
TF dot reshape and then as in actual
shape such that we modified I'll change
it into 1D array so or one the Denture
so if you put this to say six we run
that we should have an error so invalid
syntax
well this is referring from the error we
expected okay so this is it exact error
we get so the input to reshape the
tensor with eight values but the
requested shape has six so that said the
fact that you could reshape doesn't mean
you just be able to modify any sensor
and then
change that to just any type of shape
you have to make sure that when
reshaping the number of values that you
have getting the initial tensor actually
fit in this new shape of this new form
you understand so to take so here you
have eight values and you don't expect
to reshape this into six values so you
have to put this to eight so running
that now you see how wave we shift this
and we have three five six six three
five six six and then
plus six negative one two so it's kind
of like we're flattened out this Matrix
now let's do another I'll take a look at
the reshaping we could change this to
four so here we have four by two now
we're changing all these two by four
this is already two by four so we could
put this on four by two
four by two we run that so here we have
two by four now we could change it so
four by two notice that
this actually isn't exactly the same as
the transpose of this Matrix so we're
shaping it from two four to four two
doesn't find get the transpose of this
initial tensor extra shape
we could change this again let's say we
have four two four two one we run that
say that works just fine and this is
because
with this we expect eight values and
here we have this eight values
now it may happen that you will be
dealing with tensors wherein you don't
exactly know whether this is a four by
two tensor you want to get as the output
of this reshaping so you could just put
a negative one and tensor for
automatically knows that this is two so
if you run this you'll get this output
right here let's bring this out let's
have this clean it out so we print this
out
copy this print it out we have two we
run it and we see that we have exactly
the same output now if you just put a
negative one yeah you would expect to
get the same output as this so put in
this you see it automatically
understands that the value you should
have here should be eight when I look at
the concatenate function that's T of the
concat with parameters concatenate
tenses along one dimension so right here
we have this values input we have a
specified axis and then we have the name
so at the bottom yeah you can have this
values you could be a list of tensors or
just a single tensor now let's look at
these examples let's just copy this
example from here so we're going to copy
this example
but this is all right here we have T1 T2
and then let's look at the output I'll
get the output of this uh before getting
to the output we're gonna have print T
this is actually a list so let's say
print TF dot constant
T1
dot shape and then we print TF dot
constant
T2 dot shape so we have that so we've
been opening out this tool T1 and T2 and
then we're concatenating them uh let's
run this we have the shape two by three
two by three and we have this
concatenation which is four by three now
what do we notice we notice that this
first part here this first two rows
first two rows are actually T1 and the
next last two rows uh T2 now the reason
why we have this is because we'll
specify this axis this axis right here
to be equal zero now saying that X is
equals zero simply means we're doing
concatenation across the rows
we're taking this first tensor taking
this other sensor and then
we are completing the roles of this T1
right here so it's just like we were
taking let's copy this so This
concatenation operation is just like
this we have in this here completing
like this and there we go so this is
exactly what we're doing we actually
just completing this and then having
this so that's why uh yeah when you look
at this you see it's exactly the same as
what we have here so that's how the
concatenation operation is done let's go
back we have T2 T1
now we could modify this and take to one
now if you specify the axis to be equals
one it means we're doing concatenation
across the road all right across the
columns so that said
instead of adding extra rows as we just
did previously when the axis was Zero
now we're adding extra columns so we
come here and we add extra columns so
here we have seven we have eight we have
nine and then here we have 10 we have 11
and then we have 12. so that's what
we're gonna get let's go back
take that back that's fine and then
let's run this and see what we get we
see that we have one two three
seven eight nine so we add the extra
columns and then 10 11 12. so what the x
is equals one that's when we're
specifying that we'll be working on the
columns we're adding extra columns when
X is equal to zero that's with the rows
we add in extra rows
now what if we're having 3D tensors or
let's say we're having a 3D list right
here let's take this and that and then
add this
you look at you'll know the shape we'll
get from here so this is going to print
out the shapes and then let's specify
this to zero so we run that and then
we have one two three so shape one by
two by three one by two by three and
then our output
here is Two by Two by three so in fact
we're doing the concatenation on the
zeroed axis which is
this axis right here so our output is
one plus one now
um we'll go back slightly so let's get
back
to what we had previously
there's a point we didn't mention so
let's run this again we have this now
what we forgot to mention was that the
output that is only specify X is equals
one our output will be we go to the axis
one and then we add these two up so up
will be two so we fix the other axis and
then we add this two up so we have two
by six now when is zero
we're going to fix this other axis and
then we're going to add this one up to
make four by three so let's run this and
we get four by three let's go forward
we will run this again and this is what
we have so as we're saying simply
specify access zero we fix the remaining
axis and then we add this up so here we
have two by two by three
now what if we specify the axis to be
equals one if our is equals one our
output should be fixing we fix the one
and then we add this two up one by four
by three so same way concatenating uh on
the first axis here
means we'll be stacking up the rows and
we'll get this kind of output so let's
run this there we go we have one by four
by three and then we have this here
which is this and then this other one
which is the t2
if we had to do this for axis 2
we would have this inspected see we just
stack this up on the columns add its
extra columns and then here we added
other extra columns right here to obtain
this new tensor we have now
another very commonly used method in
tensorflow is the stack method as
tf.stack so you have the stack and then
here we just go straight away and then
you see the kind of output it produces
so here we have specific we specify X is
equal to zero it's kind of like similar
syntax with the concatenate so we'll
specify X is equal to zero we run that
and then we should have this so there we
go we have
instead of like with the concatenation
where we just
join these two tensors across the rows
yeah when we specify X is equal to zero
it simply means we are creating a new
axis
so if both tensors are all two by three
two by three like this we create a new
axis and now and then you axis depending
on the number of tensors we have so if
we had for example if we have to add C1
again let's add this C1 dependent number
of tensors we have we are going to have
the ship or rather we're going to have
this
axis having a lens corresponding to the
number of tensors we have so like here
we have this three so that's about here
we have three we're taking this back to
two we're gonna have two so basically we
actually stacking up this tenses and you
should be able to clearly see the
difference between the stack and the
concatenate and then using this new T1
T2 for the stack
we have that while we have the stack of
axis equals zero this is the output we
get
shape two by four by three so from here
we could understand that we have t143
t243 and then we create this extra
axis
at the zeroth position so we create this
extra axis right here so four three four
three now we add this extra axis and we
have now two four three
where basically this T1 and T2 stay
intact as you could see here we have
this is T1
and then this is T2 all the values are
intact
forming this
big tensor of sheep two by four by three
so we leave from these two 2D tensors to
this 3D tensor by just stacking up this
two tensors now when we change the Axis
or when we're working with X is equal
one
the stacking up is done such that
we having this 4343 but the outputs
we get is such that this
additional
axis is at the position one so unlike
here where this additional axis are the
position two now this additional axis
are the position one so just like we're
having let's say we're having four and
then we're having three so if x is
equals of zero we add it at this
position if x equals one we added a
disposition if x is equals two we added
a disposition
we also understand that if we have three
of this so if we have let's say T1 and
then yeah we take T1
let's run this tool if we run this two
this is what we now obtain we have here
for when X is equal to zero we have
three by four by three so let's see why
we have this uh we're having those two
well we're having four by three stacked
with four by three and then stacked
again with four by three so we have this
three
um tens has been stacked here T1 T2 and
then T1 again so here we're gonna add an
extra axis but then since we have three
of this we have with this extra Axis
Three length three so we have three by
four by three that's why we have this
right here and therefore when X is
equals one we added extra axis
so we add that extra axis here we have
four by three we add the extra axis in
the middle so yeah we have three so
that's why we have four by three by
three let's check this out we have four
by three by three
when the axis equals one
the stacking is done at this position
one here and so what you have here is
this one two three stack with seven
eight nine and again start with one two
three this is because we have t one t
two t one so if I take this off if I run
this I have one two three start with
seven eight nine so I have this one two
three here start with seven eight nine
and then to obtain the next I have four
five six start with ten eleven twelve I
have this four five six start with ten
eleven twelve and then the next is five
six two start with zero zero two five
six two stack with zero zero two one two
one stack with negative one five two
that's it one two one start with
negative one five two
so let's go back to when we had C1 right
here T1 we run that
and that's it so we understand exactly
why we have this responses here we
understand exactly why we have this
output right here
to get this for example we have five six
two stack with zero zero two and
restacked with five six two since we
have T1 T2 T1 now at this point you
could pause the video and try to
find the output when we have X is equal
to
when X is equal to we are meant to have
this so let's just recopy this is that
when x equals 2 we have four three four
three four three that's T1 T2 T1 and
then for three and then we add this axis
at the end so here we have still four
three three now to make it clearer let's
just take T1 T2
so if we have T1 T2
yeah we just have this two so in this
case we just have two now we have two
we're gonna have uh four three two so
four three two
and that's it so we have 432 unlike here
where we have four two three and here
where we have two four three that's if
we considering that we're dealing with
just T1 and T2
so that's it take that
and that's fine
so as you could see our app now before
by three by two and the stacking will be
done on the columns so let's look at uh
what we'll get let's have
this run right here let's run this
then we compare with our values here we
see we have four three two and then
this output can be seen as you taking
this row that's this first row stacking
up with this one and then
transposing it so it's kind of like
similar to what we had here one two
three seven eight nine but yeah we now
transpose it then here we have four five
six ten eleven twelve transpose
oh to obtain this we transpose this to
obtain one negative one two five one two
we transpose this
how do you look at it that way or you
could see directly that you have one
seven
there we go next
to eight
there we go next three nine
here is it and then we move to the next
where we have 14 so we have four ten
five eleven six twelve and so on and so
forth so that's how we get this output
right here
in the documentation we'll see how the
stack method can be written as the
concatenation here that's I'm reading as
a combination of the concatenation
method and the expand themes method
so yeah we have this stack of T1 T2 on
zeroed axis which produced this and then
following the exact same method we've
been given in the documentation we have
this concatenation and then we run it so
we run this and we see that we have
exactly the same answer
the reason why we have exactly the same
angle here simple you see that we have
this expand themes so if we have let's
suppose that we have this to 10 so all
we have this list made of T1 and T2
which is a which are the tensors one
stack so here we have four by three and
then we have four by three obviously
when we do expand themes of each and
every one of this that's basically what
we're doing here for all this when we do
this expand themes zeroed axis we'll be
left with one so added this extra axis
we're left with this now once we do this
we now concatenate on the zeroth axis
and we have
the output two four three that's because
we just basically add these two up so
one plus one gives us two as we saw with
concatenation so here we have 243 and
this coincides with just doing a
stacking of these two tenses T1 and T2
then we get to the method part that's
tf.pad right here we have the definition
and then we have this example so we just
look at this example
here we have this tensor T and then we
Define these patterns which we've seen
up here so we have to pass in the tensor
and the patterns uh copy with the mode
and its constant values okay by default
this is zero and here is constant but we
must put in the tensor and this patterns
now let's take a look at that as we said
we have the tensor we have this patents
which itself this is another tensor and
the way it works is we are going to add
this
tensor right here with a constant value
by default this constant value is zero
so we have gonna we're gonna do the
padding with a value of zero that's why
if you notice you have this one two
three here is a year one two three four
five six this is it and then we do this
pattern with all values surrounding it
being zeros let's copy this and check
this out in The Notebook
we run this here
okay so that's what we get now let's
modify this and say we want to have a
constant values to be equal say three we
run that and what do we notice
we notice that we still have one two
three four five six but all the
remaining values around in it uh
actually are three now we are having
this output here but how is this output
generated now if you look at this
carefully let's take this let's send
this back to a zero if you look at this
carefully
um the weight is tensor is defined that
this pattern stands as defined as such
that here we have the number of
rows above the initial tensor that's if
we have this initial tensor here we have
a certain number of rows above this
initial tensor which we are going to Pat
with this value is zero so here we have
one row above one row below so that's
why you notice here that's one this
you see we have this that's why you
notice here we have this one row above
one row below and then we have two
columns to the left that's these two
columns and then two columns to the
right so that's how we generate this uh
this uh pattern tensor right here now
let's modify this let's say we want to
have three to the right four and a half
three to the right you see here we have
now three to the right still two to the
left uh one row above and one row below
so that's it now let's change this let's
say we want to have five rows below you
see we have one two three four five six
and then all these five rows below now
we could change this method to
reflect or symmetric as we've seen here
another way of doing tensor indexing is
by using this gather method which comes
as tf.getter
yeah as usual we have the definition and
some examples to parameters understand
exactly how this works so that said
let's look at this first example where
we see how this tf.gatter does a similar
thing as the usual indexing which we've
seen already so right here we have this
tensor which is here and then we have
um the tensor that's params params three
simply means we're selecting the value
or the elements at the third position
third index so if we count here we have
0 1 2 3 this is our third index and the
upper should be P to read so right here
you see we have P3 now if we want to do
this same thing with the gather method
we just have to pass in our params and
then specify the index so you see here
specify three and then we have this
output
now let's squeeze out here unlike with
the indexing where we had for example
supposing we want to do params or want
to take in these values what we're gonna
do is just pass in say zero because yeah
this is actually zero one so one two
three so if you want to take all these
numbers we'll have one two three and
then we add the foot so here we have one
two three plus one to give us those
values so here we're gonna have P1 P2 P3
that's it B1 oh we set it from zero so
start from one so we have P1 P2 P3 which
gives us this as expected now if we want
to redo this together we have this we
pass in the params
and then we specify this indices so
right here we have one two and three we
run that
and that's fine we have P1 P2 P3 we
could also do
uh T of the range one up to four so we
have that that's fine we run that
there we go we have exactly the same
response so let's get one step back we
have this so let's play around with the
syntax now supposing we do not want to
get maybe this three consecutive
elements or any
key consecutive elements supposing we
want to get this zeroth element we want
to get the last element I want to get
this element right here so this is 0 1 2
3 4 5. so I want to get 0 that's 0 1 2 3
so I want to get zero I want to get this
last and I want to get it second to the
last so that said I'll I'll just have to
put here zero I want to get the last
element so negative one and then so that
one negative three so I run that I
expect to have
those elements you see here we have an
error so uh this guided method doesn't
understand the syntax so we should just
have we just have to use the usual
syntax here we have zero one two three
four five so we'll put in here five and
then here we have three we run that
again
there we go we have P0 P5 and P to e you
see that this permits us to do this kind
of even more complex in Dental slicing
let's take another example we have
supposing we have this tensor right here
params and then we want to have
tf.gatter
uh we pass in params and then we have
three one for example now note that this
parameters uh two is rather it's a four
by three tensor so it was of shape four
by three so we want to get one together
this three one so look at this again
let's install from some simple so let's
start from just zero you see that doing
this will get us zero one two so
um yeah we're saying that we want to get
just the first
or rather just the zeroed element and it
happens to be this one right here now
this is this other
this other params here we have the shape
we had a shape of our arms
around that shape we had a shape of
um six and then here we have on a
different ship so this is one Z and this
are the parameters 2D so the
way we approach
the index in year is slightly different
now let's look at this uh when we do
this gutter we have
the index zero selected and the default
axis is equals zero even here our
default axis was equal to zero that is
with this one right here the default
axis here this equals zero if you do
this you'll still have exactly the same
response
oh yeah we should run this and run that
so you see that we have exactly the same
response now let's get back to this our
axis is zero means that we are dealing
with this
axis right here which happens to be the
columns all right I wish happens to be
the rows
so putting out zero year simply means
wait working with the zeroth row so
we're working with this and that's why
the output is as such now if we do this
as if we do zero for example let's say
three and we run this
what we get is 0 1 2 and 30 31 32 so
we're getting this and we're getting
this this is because we're dealing with
the zero row and the third row so zero
one two three we have this and we have
this
If instead we want to do this selections
based on the columns then we'll have to
deal with the first axis so X is equal
to one
running this this is what we obtain yeah
we're saying we're dealing with a zeroth
column so we have zero ten twenty Thirty
so that's it right here and then the
third column but yeah we don't have any
third column so that's why it just by
default just places all those zeros
right here now let's change this input
for example the second column we have
two 12 22 32 212 22 32 we could change
this to zero we run that and we have 2
12 22 32 0 10 20 30. now let's modify
this let's
modify our params so let's have this
here we add this and we run it again uh
before running that let's let's go back
to zero so let's suppose the axis is
zero our shape is one by four by three
now our axis is zero so we are on this
zero axis right here
and if you considering the zero axis
yeah we have
only this so basically have only this
now uh we're saying we want the second
so we want the second element of this
uh 3D tensor but there is no second
element since we only have just just one
so what happens is we have all the zeros
right here now the next is we say we
want the zeroth element since the zero
element actually exists we see what we
get now is exactly this so it's
basically giving us back this year
now we turn this to one what do we or
what are we supposed to get
since yeah we are on this axis we're
focusing on those rows focusing on these
rows we pick out the second row so zero
one two we pick out the second row and
the zeroth row so let's run this and we
expect to get 20 21 22 and zero one two
so let's run that
there we go 20 21 22 012 which is what
we expected to get now
uh let's double this so let's have this
supposing we have this step of 3D
um tensor let's modify say this one
let's modify that
zero zero
um
two
and that's it so let's run this now and
what do we get we see that
um since we are on this we've picked out
the first items let's let's even go back
to zero let's run this
yeah we see again that we still have the
zero zero because there is no second
element but if we had one right here if
we had one yeah we don't have the zeros
anymore we have this here here is it and
then we have the zero and here is it
yeah now let's uh put this back to two
and then send this access to one we run
that
and here's what we get so as we are
saying we're working with this axis uh
this one fixed we're working with this
axis we just function with the rows so
for this element right here we check out
the rows what is the second row this is
the second row and this one so that's
what we have here and then for the next
element where the second row we have
zero five fifty five and three one
twenty one so that's how we obtain this
now we have this other method gather ND
so it's slightly different from the
getter uh what it does is it gathers
slices from params into a tensor with
shape specified by the induces so this
indices is gonna
influence the output shape
so you have to say whereas in tf.gether
that when working with a gather method
indices defines the slices into the
first dimension of params and the TF dot
gather ND indices Define slices into the
first n dimensions of params
that's it let's look at some examples so
right here we have some examples
here we have this indices The params
Gather ND it takes in the params and the
indices note that unlike with a getter
yeah we don't have this axis argument so
the 10 The Gather ND doesn't take in the
axis argument and we just basically have
this params and then the indices so
let's see how this works we have a
program uh this tensor right here oh
this list which will subsequently become
a tensor after getting to this method
and then as it was said on the
documentation we're gonna have a tensor
which is going to get the shape of uh
the indices right here
but the way it's going to get this is
such that we're gonna have this zeroed
element of params and the zero element
of params happens to be this here is the
zeroth element of params and then here
we're going to have the first element of
param so this happens to be this so
let's run this and we'll see what that
gives us we have here A B C D so that's
fine we have exactly the same as params
now if we take this off so let's run
that
would have a b we have this 1 by 2
shaped output yeah we have this a b
right here notice how since we've picked
out the zeroed element we have this this
is actually a zero element so we take
this and then we replace right here and
we get this output
let's modify this
uh to take e and then F so here we have
e f that's it and let's do two for
example we run this and we should get EF
so that's it we have EF now let's do two
with one so two one what do we have we
have F now why do we have F we have F
here because we're picking up the second
row that's zero one two this row and the
First Column so that's why we have just
this F right here
this is different from the getter where
when we do this that's when we have like
this index index is specified two one
and then wait let's run this
and then we do TF dot gather
params indices
here yeah we should have
this year EF that's two and then cd1
so we should note that with those gather
ND our output is our shape is defined by
this indices right here so uh what we
have is two one we pick this up and then
there we go here's what we have whereas
we're together
first of all we have an axis which is
zero so we're working on the zeroth axis
that is we're working with all the rows
and then we're picking out the second
row and the zero already on the first
row so that's why we have efcd
stick this off
we take this other example here now we
have this indices so obviously we know
that our output is going to take the
shape so we expect to have this kind of
output but then what values are we gonna
put in this output so that's what we're
going to look now we have this yeah zero
one
since there's a 3D shaped as a 3D tensor
we have zero one we say zero we're
picking up this first element here the
zeroth element and one would say one
we're picking up this element right here
now zero one means we're picking up this
element and then one means we're picking
up this because first of all when you
pick up this element you have two
elements in this element so we have this
here and we have this here so when we
pick up this element
that's the zero element right here we
now have to pick up this first element
or the element of the first position so
here we have the zero position and then
we have the first position so that's how
we have c0 d0
now for this other one right here so we
already know that we will have an output
which will look like this so we'll have
c0 Z zero it actually
strings so you understand that uh here
we have
um one zero now one year means we after
these two elements we have out of this
one and this element right here we're
picking out this one so we pick this one
here and then after picking this one
we're gonna pick out the zeroth element
so we're having two elements this zeroth
and this first element we pick out this
one so we have a one B one so right here
we should have a one and B1 now let's
run this and
we confirm that we have exactly the
values we expected
now if after picking this if after
picking for example here if we pick this
zeroth element and then we pick the
first element so we pick the zeroth and
then we've picked this first element
right here now what if we want to pick
that's if we pick this first element in
this element we have two elements that's
c0 and Z zero what if you want to pick
this zeroth element so if you pick the
zero element we should have c0 and now
here we'll pick this first element we
pick the zeros that's a one B one what
if we pick the first element that's B1
so pick this one right here we run that
which we have c0 and B1 so that's it
let's take a little example if we have
this indices given to us and then we
have the params and we're trying to get
together Gather in the uh we're trying
to get it up
right here now what would have is output
as usual would be of similar shape with
the indices now we have zero one so
notice how we're having here a two e
dimensional indices so we should have
something like this 3D
there we go we have this and then
we have this
okay so we have this 3D indices now we
pick out zero one picking out zero one
simply means we're picking out the
zeroed element and then after picking
out the zero element we pick out this
first position here so we have c0 d0 and
then from here so we first of all start
by picking out C 0 d 0 C 0 d 0 and then
we have
then we have
um
the next one zero one zero we're picking
out this first element and we're picking
out A1 B1 so we have this
A1 B1 that's it
um
we're done with this first part so we
close that so we have this here we have
this
2D tensor right here which is like this
one and then we move on so uh for the
next we have zero zero one one now zero
zero is simply this so we have the zero
and then we have this zero so we have a
let's just copy this
copy this we have a
right here
we have A1 B1 A1
B one and then one one that's picking
out this one and then this one so we
have c one Z One C One D one that's it
okay so we're done with that we could
now take this off
so that's fine
um let's now go ahead and run this and
compare uh answers here we have
um I suspected this two by two by two
that's because we have this two elements
and then for each of these elements we
have a two by two tensor so that's
normal for the shape and then here we
have c0 d0 A1 B1 a0 B zero C1 Z1
we actually have in something different
here here we have a zero B zero and here
we have A1 B1
let's understand why we should have a 0
B 0 right here we get back to this at
this position we have this zero zero now
zero zero we have the zeroed element and
uh after picking up the zero elements we
have this zeroed position zero a zero B
zero so that should be a zero B zero so
that's normal we made an error here we
should have had a zero B zero we now
look at this gather ND method while
taking into consideration this argument
that's the batch deems argument right
here by default the batch dims equals
zero so by default we have this output
right here where to obtain this zero one
uh when you say zero one you simply
saying you're taking the zeroth element
and then with the zero element you're
taking the first index so you have this
c0 d0 and then one zero means you're
taking this first position and zero so
first position
and in this first position you have this
zeroth position so A1 B1 and that's how
we get this now let's turn this by
Dimension to one
foreign
you see that we have a different output
now let's understand how this output is
gotten
you have to note that this badge themes
here is kind of like
making this method to be batch aware so
that said once we have this indices
passed in that's this and this is here
we understand that this corresponds to a
given batch that's this batch and this
corresponds to this other batch
so that said uh we haven't zero one and
then we have already picked this batch
so when we select the balance equal one
yeah we've already picked this zeroed
batch and so
um doing a zero year means we're picking
this zeroth element here and then doing
a one means after picking the zero
element we're picking this one year and
position one so that's why we have a B
zero now for the next Associates batch
aware so this matches with this second
element here
uh with this element at position one now
one here's one
and zero here is zero C1 so that's how
we obtain this right here unlike with a
farmer where we had batch dims equals
zero
let's look at this other example we have
this indices
we have the params now uh when the batch
DMS equals zero saying that you want to
have zero one it's just like picking
this so we pick this and then we have
one which is c0 d0 so that's why we have
this C zero zero one zero we're picking
this we're picking this
element at position one and then zero is
A1 B1 so C 0 D 0 a 1 b 1 and then a 0 B
0 c 1 Z1 we've seen this already now
when you say batch dims equal one what
you're saying is
all the indexing you will do here will
match with this zeroth element so this
zero element here will match with this
so it's not batch aware and then this
first element will match with this
that said
um zero one yeah means oh first of all
we've already selected this so zero
means we're picking out this zero
element and then one means we're picking
out this one so we're gonna have B zero
so we have B zero one zero we've already
picked this one so we have C we have
this one zero will be this and this so
we have B zero C zero now for the next
we have is batch aware so we've already
picked this
and then zero is this
zero zero is only picking only this one
so we have a one now for the next one
one means we're picking this one and
then we picking this D1 so we have B
zero C zero a one Z one now let's run
this and we hope to get a exact answer
so here we have C zeros B zero C zero as
suspected and then a One D one
you could continue exploring other
methods oh now move on to racked tensors
so
we have here TF the right you have this
overview uh we try to understand first
of all what rack tenses are about
to understand the react tensors let's
take this example we have this tensor 2D
could print out this shape tensor 2 D
shape we have that
which is four by three
now let's copy this
and then paste it out here and modify
this one so we'll modify this so we have
this three just like this to three and
that's it now let's point out
tensor
[Music]
2D let's print out tensor 2D there we go
print out the shape
what we get here is an expected error
can't convert non-rectangular
python sequence to a tensor so as you
could see here
tensors are meant to be rectangular that
is if we decide to have four rows like
in this case we have four rows
that's this this this and this then each
of these four rows must have the same
number of columns so here we have three
columns this one one column there's
three columns there's two columns hands
this arrow is thrown here
but then it happens that sometimes we
may be working with data which
comes in this form that is we may have
data where we could have for example
those rows or we have this row uh having
three columns and this other row having
one column this row other row even
having say
five columns go we have this kind of
bitter and the way tensorflow deals with
this is by using racked tensors now
let's see how to create a rack tensor to
clear react tensor is quite easy we have
tensor
let's see tensor erect is equals
TF dot
racked.com stands so instead of just TF
dot constant we have TF direct that
constant and there we go so we could
also have this is like a simple list so
could have this as a list
put it this way we're gonna have a list
and then just pass this in here so we
have tensor
2D
now let's go ahead and print out a shape
we have tensor racked that's it let's
run that
we have an invalid syntax here
um
okay it's because of this so let's run
this again and there we go we see we
have four by noon now four because we
have four rows that's fixed but then we
don't have an exact number of columns so
we just have unknown year meaning we
don't know exactly the number of columns
we're dealing with
but nonetheless we have erect tensor
which we've just created so we'll see
here we have this TF the react tensor
unlike
um with this that's less you know tensor
2D if you print out tensor 2D you'll see
you have TF Dot
constant now you this actually a list
solicit here that constant
so you have that constant and then we
have that
oh we have an error here let's let's
come let's use this
errors because it's not rectangular so
that's normal so okay there we go we see
we have tf.tensor here and then here we
have let's run this again here we have
tf.raged tensor so this is an example of
a racked tensor
wherein we have
non-rectangular data like in this case
here
apart from this constant method which we
just saw we also have methods like the
Boolean mask now with a Boolean mask we
pass in our tensor or
a list and then we pass in The Mask
let's check out on some examples so
we'll see here we have this one two
three four five six seven eight nine
we're passing the mask true false true
false false false and true false false
notice how wherever we have the false
this data or this element in the data is
taken off so this tool is taken off and
we're left with one three
so that's why we have one three right
here because we have true true and then
here we have all false so this is an
empty list here we have true false false
so we left with just seven so that's it
and from this we form this racked tensor
right here now we could also do this for
rows so instead of just specifying for
each and every element we just say true
false true and then this understands
automatically that this means
our first row is going to be left out so
it's all right our fence was going to be
taken so we have one two three
maintained and then this next is false
so it's going to be taken off
and then this next is true
you could check on this other methods uh
we are going to look at the tf.racked
tensor this rack tensor class contains
several methods as you could see here
let's check on this from Roll lens
method right here to see how we could
create rack tenses it takes a
potentially racked sensor
the Rowlands are specified the name and
then validate so let's see how this
works we have this
input right here and then we have this
roll lens specified
so we run this
what do we get we have three one four
one empty list five nine two six empty
list now Hearts has gotten you see that
with this row lens we're saying okay
we're gonna start from this first
position from the zeroth position and
then the first four or the next four we
have will form a row so we have three
one four one from in this row
and then from here we say the next we're
gonna have is gonna be an empty
list uh the next row we're gonna have is
gonna be empty so that's why we have
this and then from here we continue from
our position where we go to the next
three so we've gone to the next four at
this point we created this empty and
then now we're going to the next three
five nine two that's how we have this
and then from here we have the next one
six and then we have an empty so if we
take this empty off
I will take that zero obviously you
don't have the empty list anymore so
that's it that's how we
can create those react tensors from the
Rowlands
from that we will now look at the from
row limits method here again we have
this input values we have the row limits
let's see how that works
here since we're given the raw limits we
have this first value four so we come
and put ourselves at this
position right here we simply go one two
three four elements with Excel server
disposition we create this first element
of our rack tensor there we go and then
for the next four we are still at that
same position so we move we still at
that same position since we are at the
same position
and that we've already used up this
first four positions we have this empty
list again we move to the seventh
position so we go let's go this way we
move to the seventh position here we are
at this point we pick this up
so here we have 592 and then from the
seven position we move to the eighth
position so we go to this position right
here we pick this up we have the six
again we have this eight position we're
still at the same position since we've
already taken off all of this we just
have an empty list so that's how this
works let's now take one last you could
always come back to the documentation to
explore all those other methods
with the from row splits matter what we
do is we actually checking out in this
Rose Place we've been giving here
each element and the next element so we
have zero to four see right here zero to
four we pick out this zero to four
and yeah we're confirmed that this
position this position here is zero this
position here is one this position here
is two this position here is three and
then this position here is four so when
we say zero to four we actually taken
from this zero one two three four so if
that's about this position and we get
this four first four elements that's how
we get three one four one and then the
next we still at four so we're still at
this position so we've already gotten
this three one four one so we just have
an empty list here now we move to we
have four to seven so we go again from
here this is four this is five this is
six this is seven so we have all this
five nine two and then we have seven to
eight we have the seven and then yeah we
have eight so we get six and then eight
to eight since we are the same position
we have this empty list right here
we could also convert tensors directly
into sparse tensors using the from
tensor method so here we have this
tensor defined it says rectangular and
then we could automatically convert this
into a sparse or rather into a racked
tensor
this from tensor method takes in this
lens parameter where with this lens
given to us we're able to
take only certain parts of our right to
tensor so yeah since we have one it
means for the first row or for this row
that we have here we're going to take
only this one or the first element the
next we're going to take no element so
we have an empty list the next we're
going to take all three elements so we
have six zero zero
so that's it for the rack tensor you can
always explore all the sort of methods
the documentation
it should be noted that many times we
will have to deal with data which
contains many zeros
it should be noted that many times will
have to deal with data which contains
many zeros
and a more efficient way of treating and
storing these kinds of data
is by using sparse tensors so we get to
tf.sparce right here clicking sparse
tensor
there we go
we'll see how to create the sparse
tensors right here we specify the
indices we're gonna understand this soon
so let's say we have one one it's
actually 2D so yeah we have one one yeah
we could have say three four there we go
and then we specify the values this is
going to take
let's say we're going to have 11 and
then 56. you specify the shape
let's say it's five by six
there we go we have indices
values and dense shape so here we've
defined this tense of sparse run it and
then let's print this out so here we
have chainsaws bars there we go
we see that we have exactly the same
values we put out here but then let's
understand how this relates to a usual
tensor or how we could map this to a
tensor now to do this let's do tf.parse
dot to dance
so not that we are not going to have
those parts that sparse 10 so we're just
doing two of those parts that two dance
directly so we take this and we pass in
10 Source parts we run that and what do
we get we have this five by six
tensor right here
which happens to be what we had defined
here so we had to find the shape to be
found by six we said that at the
position one one that's at this this is
the zero Row the first row so we have
this position first row first columns
one one we want to fit in this value 11.
and we also said that at the position
three four one of it in the value of 56
so we go one two three that's sorry zero
one two three and then zero one two
three four so this is a position three
four right here and then we'll put in
this value 56. so that's how we're able
to map this back to uh
usual tensor
then you will notice that all the
remaining values are zeros so those are
stances permit us
to work with these kinds of tenses more
efficiently
this last tensor type we'll be looking
at is the
string tensors
so yeah we have tf.strings and then we
have this different methods which we
could use
before looking at those methods let's
see how to create a simple
string tensor so right here we have
tensor string called a tensor string
equals TF dot constant so basically we
just have a list made of
string elements so hello
I am
a string so that's it that's
bring this out we have tensor string we
run that
and there we go we have this
string tensor right here which hasn't
defined the type string and then we have
the different elements which make up our
string
you have as we have seen previously all
these string Methods right here let's
look at this join method with this join
method we are able to combine several
elements of this list together and with
a specific separator
by default our separator is empty string
right here
so that's it let's do this let's say we
want to have
all these elements joined together so we
just have TF that strings dot join and
then we pass in tensor string so we pass
in terms of string our separator
our separator is equals let's say for
now let's keep it at its default value
we run that and what do we get we have
hello I am a string now let's uh suppose
that we want to have a separito which is
the space so let's have this separator
hello now there's some space between now
let's uh modify the separator we'll put
a plus
uh and we run that
and there we go hello I am a string with
this separator right
we have other methods like the length
the land basically tells us how long our
string is so here
um in the case where we have this you
see you have hello tensorflow and you
have this
Unicode string you see how we're able to
get that this length is five one two
three four five this is ten and then
this is four
we have the lower meter which converts
all uppercase characters into your
respective lowercase Replacements we
have the n-grams method
and all these other methods which you
could explore
so that's it for tensors we now move on
to variables
to better understand tens of variables
let's come back to this model which we
have defined at the beginning of this
course this values A1 A2 B1 B2 which are
given initial values get updated as we
train our model
and so we need to use variables which
can be updated as we do model training
that said instead of using the
tf.constant we're gonna have
um X VAR
X bar which is equals TF dot variable so
this is how Define this and a variable
must always be initialized so yeah we'll
pass an X and then we print out X bar
and there we go
we have this TF dot variable its name
shape data type and it's content uh we
could include this so let's say we want
to have VAR one
let's specify that's his name so we have
that and now we'll specify the
variable's name var1
here's how we create a tensorflow
variable notice also that we have this
trainable argument right here which says
whether doing the training we update
that variable or not
and so if this is false then doing
training this variable wouldn't be
updated if it's true then this variable
can be updated during training and then
we have this other arguments which you
could explore now well this here the
variable has other methods so we have
the assign method for example
and we'll see an example of how this is
used we have this variable defined so we
pass in this number one and then we
assign its value to two so now when you
print out this V what you're going to
get is this new
um
value for our variable now you see we
have the assign ad this other method
right here with the assign ad we're
simply doing addition on the elements
now variable
so let's check on assign sub this assign
subtract here we're just doing
subtraction
so here we have X VAR and we could do
some subtraction so we would say xvar
dot assign sub of this three four so it
takes in this three four and then what
goes on here is we're gonna have one
that's the actual value of x bar now X
bar is actually this so okay as one so X
bar we have this one minus this three
and then this two minus is four so let's
run this what do we get we have X bar
negative two negative two if we modify
this to six we have negative five
negative eight reason being that the
first time we did the update we went to
negative two we had negative two
negative two now we're doing the
subtraction so we have a negative two
minus three
negative five and then negative 2 minus
six negative eight so now we have
negative five negative eight let's go
ahead and and add eight so let's just do
this we have ADD we run that we should
have zero zero
so that's fine we have zero zero because
negative five negative eight plus five
eight would give us zeros
so as usual you could check up on all
these other methods in the documentation
then another important point which we
need to mention is the fact that you
could decide on what device you want
your variable to be so generally we have
CPUs uh gpus CPUs let's check on this
runtime let's change runtime type you
see that personally we're using the GPU
so if we say none then that's the CPU
CPU and then let's do that so here we
could have with
tf.device and then we specify that
device in this case we have GPU so we
have that GPU with this we could Define
our X bar so you define your X bar in
this scope and you're actually saying
that you want your X bar so X bar that's
variable one on X bar to B in this GPU
now if you wanted to be in a CPU you
just simply specify your CPU and that's
it now you could also uh let's print
this out first so we have X bar
let's run that and then you could check
out the device which is found so check
out the device see it's in a CPU
if we modify this to GPU we run that
it's the GPU
you should also note that this could be
done with just a simple tensor so we
could have X tensor CF dot constant and
then 0.2
there we go print out X tensor dot
device so let's run that and we see we
have this now we could
let's do this
copy that there we go
we have now let's put your CPU so we
have the CPU and then let's take this
off
there we go we run that and we compare
so here we have a GPU and then we have a
CPU for our tensor
that said it's possible to initialize so
you could initialize this right here
like this let's say we want to have one
two
three four so we want to have one three
four that's our X let's say this is X1
and then yeah we want to have X2 which
is TF constant
and then we want to have here one so
let's say we have this year
um let's put this list so we want to
have this X1 and X2 which is in a CPU
initializing the CPU and then we want to
carry out the computations in the GPU so
that
this computations could run faster so
right yeah what we're going to do is
we're going to have X3 which is equals x
1 plus X2 so as simple as that now
obviously broadcasting will happen here
and then we're gonna have one one one
which when we add with all this gives us
2 4 and then five so that's it let's now
print out our X1
um let's take this off let's print out
X1
print out let's print out X1 and it's
where it's found so X1 the device
copy that
take this off
um that's it we have now X1 X2
X2 X2 rather X3 here X3 so let's run
this and see what we get uh we see we
have
um this CPU CPU and then here GPU now we
have two four five so output which is
expected so that's it with
just looked at tensorflow variables
and this marks the end of this part on
tension variables don't forget to like
And subscribe so you never miss amazing
content like this and in case you want
to gain some solid foundation on linear
algebra you could check out our course
see you next time
what's up everyone and welcome to the
session where we build a linear
regression model and a deep neural
network to predict the current price of
a second hand car based on the number of
years that car has been used its number
of kilometers traveled its rating
condition economy the present state of
the economy top speed horsepower and
torque and so we're gonna build models
which when given these inputs parameters
predict this current price as we could
see in those results right here where we
have in blue the models predictions and
in Orange the actual price so before
moving on it's important to note that we
are gonna follow this machine learning
development life cycle where we start
with defining the task we'll look at the
data source we're going to prepare the
data build machine learning models which
bring meters learn from this data to the
right arrow functions for this learning
process and then get into the training
and optimization
from here we're going to measure the
performance of the model on this data
we're going to validate and test our
model and then finally we are going to
take up some creative measures to
improve the performance of this model
our task here is to predict the price of
the used car using some input features
in this case we've selected just one
feature that is say the horsepower so
supposing we have this and then we have
the price in thousand dollars
and then we want to make use of this
input data right here that is this
horsepower and the corresponding prices
to train a model such that when given
the horsepower we'll be able to predict
the corresponding price of that used car
or when given this 150 will be able to
predict the price of their used car
based on a model which has been trained
on this data right here plotting out
this data we're going to have this on
the x-axis and then the price on the
y-axis as you could see on this plot
based on a given horsepower we are able
to
predict that the price of the second
hand car now if we drop points like this
if you draw lines like this from those
points you see that we have a continuous
range of real valued outputs right here
and since our outputs here can take up
continuous values we term our task as a
regression task
now let's modify this problem so you
better understand a regression problem
yeah we have this horsepower and then if
we modify this such that we are gonna
insert predict whether the car is going
to have uh the car is going to be noted
as expensive or not so instead of
putting the price we may want to predict
whether
that car is expensive or not so let's
say for all cash below say eight let's
say 8.5 they are cheap and then so we'll
call that cheap C and then greater than
8.5 we have the expensive cars
so yeah we have Grant equals to here we
have cheap here is expensive
and so from here we may have a different
kind of task that is one in which we
want to say
if based on some input or some inputs
because you may have many inputs right
here based on the inputs
the car
falls under one of those categories
right here so you could see that this
kind of problem is one in which our
outputs are discrete see we have just
two options
and then we this problem well we're
trying to predict the price we don't
just have some two or three or four
options which you want to pick from we
have an infinite number of actions since
the prices can go from let's say uh a
thousand dollars we suppose that the
fixed the minimum to a thousand dollars
and then the maximum to a hundred
thousand dollars so we could uh fix this
to 100k from Kate from 1000 to 100 000
but the values fall under this range
which is actually an infinite number of
possibilities unlike here where we have
a finite number of possibilities
we now move on to the data and before
diving into that let's look at a big
picture so here we are having a model
which is going to fit in this inputs and
the outputs such that later on we could
have this inputs fed and then we obtain
the outputs notice the difference the
change in direction of the arrows so
initially we have this inputs so we
could have this inputs right here let's
take this off we could have this inputs
that is this X and then this y so here
we go we have this inputs
and then uh after the model trains we
will now pass in just this and then we
get this one automatically so let's get
straight away into how we're gonna
prepare this data such that it could be
passed into this model right here here
we have the second hand cars that is
sent made available on the Chicago
platform by mayank Patel here we have
a description of our data set so we have
this different features which will be
using to predict the rise of the
secondhand car so that said you could
see here you could get more details so
basically here's how I did a set as you
could see and then uh by clicking on
this so you could start and then
you could get to this compact view
column view here you see that
we have the ID which is we're we're not
going to use this because this actually
not pedophile data set but just an ID
then we have this on road old
feature right here though isn't actually
well explained because we don't clearly
see exactly what it signifies
nonetheless we have
let's take this off
we have this mean and the standard
deviation so as we had seen the previous
video we could have this and most of our
values uh around the mean
that is most values we get in this
data set for the on-road old feature
live between the mean this is Mule the
mean and sigma standard deviation lie
between the mean minus the standard
deviation and the mean plus the standard
deviation so in this range we have most
of the values so this simply means most
of our values lie between
602k as you could see there
Plus or rather 602k minus
558.4 K so that should be about
543.6 so if you subtract this 58
.4 we have
500 and
.6 so this means our values fall in this
range now most of our values fall in the
range
543.6 and
602 point this one two plus
58.4 so that is 660
0.4 so muscle values fall in this range
right here so that's what we mean by
having this mean and the standard
deviation so we we're going to have this
same right here now we have other
features let's take this off we have
other features as you could see we have
onroad old and on-road now which uh
wasn't very well explained we wouldn't
use this and then we have the number of
years that's obviously the number of
years of usage of the car
you see we have missing or missing
values we have known number of
mismatches known and valid a thousand so
this is kind of like cleaned theater uh
we have the mean that is 4.56 years and
the standard deviation 1.72 years so
most of all
cars in this data set have been used for
or most of them were falling under the
range for the 4.56 minus 1.72 and 4.56
plus 1.72 years so number of kilometers
covered there we go we have the rating
that's the car radiant at the moment you
want to buy it the condition and the
moment you want to buy it you see the
the mean right here
the current state of the economy uh the
top speed of the car
the car's horsepower and that's it so
here are the different features we have
and which we'll use in predicting a cars
current price so that said we could
download this for free so we have this
downloaded we now get into our collab
notebook where we're gonna do the
preparation of this data so here we have
this three Imports we have tensorflow
for our models we have pandas for
reading
and processing data uh we have c bond uh
this is going to be for visualization so
that's it now you don't need to have any
prior knowledge on those two as we're
going to explain every single step of
our data preparation and visualization
processes we've now uploaded our data
set right here the strain.csv file where
you download it from the cargo platform
you could see it right here so double
clicking on this gives us this
file we have here now click on 100
um yeah we have 10 per page okay let's
say I want to get 100 per page so that's
it we have this different data points
right here now that said as we could see
we have
the ID on-road old on road now the years
number of kilometers radiant conditions
economy top speed HP uh torque and then
the current price so that's it that's
for each and every little point and now
let's do this so let's break this up so
we could do this we could break this up
so if we break this up like this
you see we have this
first section
our inputs
and we have this
other sections right here
all this this other section actually we
have this this section our outputs so
here is now our X and here we have the Y
yeah if we suppose that we have totally
n data points that is if we have uh if
we count all this data points and we
have n of them then we could have the
shape or we could represent those inputs
in a tensor of shape n by yeah we're not
taking this we're not going to take this
column we're not going to take less
we're not going to take this column
we're not going to use this column
because we don't understand it very well
we're not going to use this we're going
to use this so we have one two three
four
five six seven and eight so we have n by
eight
that's it that's our input X that's the
shape of our input X and here we have n
by one
so this is a shape of our output tensor
if you're able to put this data which
you've been given the CSV file in uh the
form of tensor with the shapes then you
could pass this now into a model
like this let's call this Emma model
pass this in and then train this model
such that when you come now with new
data
the model is able to predict the current
price
now to read CSV files we are going to
make use of this pandas library right
here is here we will Define how we've
imported this as PD so that's why we
have in this year so this particularly
pandas and then we have read CSV so this
method is used in Reading CSV files like
the train.cs file we have here and that
will specify the separator
let's open up this file uh with Excel
there we go yes what we get is very
similar to what we've seen already
which closes up and now let's open this
up with
oh notepad it's okay that's it so you'll
notice now that this is our same dealer
but the way it's put out is quite
different as you could see all our
column heads are separated by those
Commerce so we separate each column by a
comma you could see that clearly from
this and then when you go to the next
row we also have the Separation by
Commerce let's do this let's put this
link so we see this one see linked right
here we have this number right here
linked to this
we have this next number linked to this
and so on and so forth so that's it and
that's why we are having comma separated
values format so this is the meaning of
the CSV format comma recipient values so
we see each and every value is separated
by a comma that's each and every value
which makes up this row is separated by
a comma and that's how
csvs are formed and
you should Now understand why in this
code when we read the CSV we will
specify that
our values are separated by Commerce now
in a case where you have
um bitter and then you have something
like this so you may have this uh
semicolons everywhere so let's say we
have the semicolons we're going to save
it as a different file so we could have
the semicolons
there we go we now have all the
separators common columns are separated
with the semicolons we save this
and we've now already right here so
that's what we have see we have this
right here now let's uh go ahead and
read this so we've created this ditter
and we could say did it ahead you see
data.head we run that and you see we get
the first
five rows of our data and straight away
you could already do stuff like this
data shape
you see we already get the shape of our
data we have a thousand by 12. now uh
let's get it as semi so let's just copy
this so we'll copy that and paste it out
here and then let's run it with
supposing uh what is separated by
Commerce so let's run that and this is
what we get you see we have this head
which is not actually well formatted
because by default this formatting is
meant for comma separated values now
what if we modify this we run that again
and you notice that there is a
difference actually now so let's do this
side by side let's run that oh let's
take this back to comma so we have that
and you notice that there's a difference
now here is well formatted whereas here
is not very well formatted so that said
if you wanna
work with these kinds of data you could
always make use of the pandas Library
let's print out data that shape here let
me run that
and then yeah we print out that's the
data dot shape so
let's have that
see yeah we have one by one which is not
exactly what we expect to get
with now being able to read our data and
then put this ditter
and some sort of data structure let's
now visualize how each and every feature
right here is related with each other
and to do this we're going to use a c
bone library right here so C bone has
been imported as SNS so we have
sns.pairplot which we have here as soon
as a pair plot we pass in our data and
then we have all these features with the
output you can check out the C band the
pair plot documentation on the cbun
website so right yeah you have these
different parameters you have the data
you have
the here which has to do with coloring
and then we have this data kind which we
used the data kind or the kind of plot
for the diagonal subplots which we're
going to see shortly
so yes we'll see we've selected a KDE we
run this
the KDE actually stands for Canal
density estimate
after running this this is what we get
we see this KDE plots in the diagonal
now let's look at
um each and every one of this so let's
take off this IDs because we're going to
be using this ID on road old Android now
that's because we don't understand
exactly what the signify so we will run
this again
here's what we have now let's scroll up
a bit and now we see we have the number
of years and this plot here shows us how
the number of years is related to the
number of years
you see how this related to the number
of years uh in the diagonal we have
how each feature is related to itself so
let's reduce this
okay so here you could see how this
okay so you see how here we have this
years related to years here we have
kilometers related kilometers radians to
radians and so on and so forth so that's
the diagonal that was a kitty plot now
here we have how the years is related
to
the kilometers so we see how okay let's
take it from this so we have here this
kilometers
and then how
the years related to the kilometers here
we have years related
to the radiant
and you repeat the same process to get
all those relationships between these
different features but one very
interesting point to note here is we
could already see the relationship
between these different features and the
current price so let's take for example
here we have current price so this is a
plot showing how the years number of
years is related to the current price
and this is based on the detail we have
we see clearly from here then for each
number of years spent the current price
could go from very low to very high
now if we move to the kilometers you see
a certain pattern you notice that as we
increase in the number of kilometers
covered by the car the overall current
price of the car drops so this is one
very interesting feature to note
we see a similar pattern to this years
with the rating the condition the
economy the top speed HP and torque so
here is how each feature is related to
the current price
at this point we convert our data into a
tensor so we have tensor data equals T
of the constant and we pick in this data
so we do this and we run that and there
we go we have our tensor data so that's
it let's print out this without a shape
so we have that there we go we see we
have our tensor of type float 64.
obviously you could do some casting so
we could say tensor
there equals tf.cast of 10 Star theater
and then we specify we want to have an
INT say all right I want to have a float
say 16 so let's run that again
a problem which arises now is we have
some values which are converted into
Infinity
the reason why we have this is because
some of these values are too large to be
stored as flute 16
data types so we're gonna put this 32
you see we run that and everything is
intact
another important step to take is to
randomly Shuffle our data
So to avoid any biased based on the way
in which the data was gathered within
this random shuffling such that
this other right here is no longer
respected
so let's do that all we need to do we
have our tensor data is now equals TF
the random.shuffle so we have that and
we pass intense our data
that's it let's print out tensor there
let's say we print out the first five
elements so let's
let's print that out
here's what we get but then let's copy
this so you could see the difference
before and after the shuffling so let's
say we have this let's take this off
let's have that and then we have our 10
sardir let's run this again we print out
our sensor data you see we have this and
then
we print out this shuffled tensor data
you see that here this ID Auto was
respected one two three and so on and so
forth whereas here we have
551 567 229 557 uh 402 so we've actually
shuffled our data and then let's take
this off now
so we'll Shuffle our data
and then we're ready
to break this data up
such that we have both the inputs that's
X and the outputs y are the output y
uh before continuing let's add this
little text here so we have this text we
add a text and we say yeah we're doing
theater preparation
so that's it put that in bold and we'll
find so oh we have that data preparation
now
um right here as we're saying we need to
get this x and the Y let's start by
getting the X so here we have X tensor
leader that's it and then we pick out
all the rows so obviously we're
interested in getting all the rows
interested in getting all uh 1000 or
1000 rows but then we're not interested
in some columns we're not interested in
this column this column this column and
this column so we're interested in just
this uh rather this so that said we have
here zero one two
three so we're going to take from 3
right up to this position right here so
that's it so we do that we just have
here
um we pick out everything and then in
this next we have three right up to
negative one so let's bring out a shape
uh before printing out the shape let's
look at this and get that shape before
putting it out so normally we should
have a thousand by twelve but since
we're picking out just the inputs now we
have a thousand by
one two three four five six seven eight
so we have now a thousand by eight so
running this should give us just that
we run that and there we go we have a
thousand by eight if you bring this out
let's print out the first five
uh we have that
there we go we have just this now
notice how your this first three values
have been taken off and we left with
this right up to this value so that's it
and then the current price two has been
taken off we repeat the same process
to get the output so here we have y
um that's it okay but now we get in
other rows that's true but we getting
just that last column so that's it
um yeah you know why
and that's fine
so that's what we get for y uh notice
that here we have the shape which is
actually just one D so what we could do
is after getting this we could expand
beams so we have TF dot expand them so
add that extra Dimension so we have to
have the expand themes and then we put
that we specify the axis
here we have negative one so we run that
again and what do we get that's what we
get we have five by one just like here
we have uh shape five by eight now we
have five by one unlike previously
where we had
just this 1D shape
uh let's stick this
um
five here so previously we had just this
one the shape now we've added this extra
Dimension so that it matches that of the
inputs we have here
from this point another very common
transformation which we could do on our
theater to enable
our model train faster is by normalizing
this data
in fact we actually normalize the inputs
that is we take for every input
we subtract the mean
and we divide by the standard deviation
in this example here the mean of this
eight values is around 138 so that means
if one normalizes data we're gonna have
minus
138 divided by the standard deviation
let's say the standard deviation is 150
for example so this means this point is
going to be converted
into
negative 0.193
every now take a value like 206 we're
going to have 206
minus 138
divided by 150
we should now give us around 0.45
so if you notice
our input features have been rescaled
before passing into the model
and to carry out those features killing
tensorflow has this
normalization layer right here which is
part of the TF that keras.layers now we
haven't spoken much about the other
Keras because we have not gotten into
the modeling
but for now just note that in this TF
that carries the layers we have this
normalization
class which can be defined by specifying
an axis the mean and the variance
that said we have from tensorflow dot
caress dot layers we are going to import
normalization so that's it let's run
that and then we get to use this
normalization layer
before looking at our data let's see how
we could use this normalization layer
with the final normalizer then we have
normalization we pass in nothing inside
there but therefore the axis is negative
one we'll look at it shortly and then
here we're gonna have the X to be
normalized so we have X to be normalized
which is this tensorflow
denser right here let's say we want to
have three four five six seven there we
go and then we do normalizer
and we pass in X to be normalized so
that's it we have pass this and we see
we have exactly the same output that's
because here we haven't specified the
mean and the variance so we just have
this uh the input as an output now let's
go ahead and specify the mean so if we
say we want to have a mean of let's say
let's if we look at this let's say five
and then the variance of C4
um we run that and there we go what do
we notice we notice that this inputs are
being
we scaled into this new inputs now let's
add another
rule right here so we want to have four
say five six seven let's keep it simple
so we have this okay let's say eight so
we have this next row that's it and what
do we do we run this
let's correct that there we go we run
that and we see we have this normalized
properly those were not in that scenes
by default the axis is equals negative
one so by therefore we have this x is
equal negative one it means this
normalization here is done with respect
to the columns so uh if you could recall
from our previous section we have our
shape two by five and picking the eyes
is negative one means we're picking this
axis here and uh this actually
corresponds to the columns that's one
two three four five so we have all five
columns and then for each column we are
doing the normalization so practically
what we're doing here we're doing three
minus five divided by the variance we
should speak we normalize that four
minus five divided by the variance 4 we
have the value and so on and so forth
we've made a slight errands definition
is actually x minus the mean divided by
the standard deviation
so it's not a variance not divided by
the variance but the standard deviation
now we also know that the standard
deviation
squared
is equals the variance
so basically uh when we have this
variance to obtain the standard
deviation we simply find the square root
of our variance so in this case our
variance is four so standard deviation
is two
um if we replace here by 2 our mean is
five
that's it and now let's pick X let's
take X for example to be
um this to be right here so if we have
three we see when we run three should
have negative one and if you pick four
you should have negative 0.5 so that's
it so that's how we get this now let's
take another example
but in this example we don't specify the
mean and the variance now you should
note that um it's not in every situation
where you could get the mean and the
variance up front so there are some
cases or in fact in most cases you just
have the data so you wouldn't always go
and
calculate this mean and variance upfront
so what tensorflow allows us to do
is to obtain this mean and variance
automatically
so the tensorflow permits us to adapt to
the data we're given so if we're given
this data for example what we're going
to do is get the mean and variance for
this column that's this column right
here middle 34 and then get the mean and
variance for this column for this column
this column this column and be able to
normalize our data so just like here
where we suppose the mean and variance
for each and every column was five four
um yeah we're gonna get the mean and
variance for each and every column
Garden automatically so let's look at
that we don't need to put them in
variance now so we'll just let that go
could take this off too uh since by
default the x is already negative one so
we have that and then what we do is we
do
normalizer dot adapt so we're gonna
adapt to this our data we add that to
the normalized ditter and then uh we
pass the normalizer we pass X
normalizing this to obtain this now so
this is what we obtain when we adapt
automatically to our data now let's
understand what goes on we have three
and four uh here the mean is 3.5 so
that's clear so we have uh x minus 3.5
and divided by the standard deviation
if we have two values three and four
um is clear the mean is going to be 3.5
that's going to be in the middle and
then if we have a mean of 3.5
so we have something like this our
standard deviation should be uh 3.5
minus 0.5 gives us three so here we have
our mean minus the standard deviation to
give our uh least possible value so here
we have a standard deviation of 0.5
so is that 3.5 minus the standard
deviation gives us 3 and still 0.5 so
it's a 3.5 plus 0.5 gives us four so
that's it so
coming back here if we take this 0.5 and
we put in the value
3 we run that you see we should uh let's
correct this you see we have negative
one so that's how we have negative one
year and when we put four
you see we have one now if we move to
this next you have four and five and we
maintain the same mean and standard
deviation you see we wouldn't get those
answers right so let's take this with
five you see here we have three which is
not what we get here see when we have
five five is transformed to one and this
is made possible because we get the mean
and the variance for each and every
column so that said uh when it's four
and five we have a mean of 0.5 or 4.5
standard deviation 0.5 so if we change
this now 4.5 0.5 which is so far you see
we have negative one again and then five
oh we have one
so if we modify this now let's take this
to
let's say 10 let's run that what do you
see we have negative one one why do we
have this is because the mean of this is
um seven so yeah we're gonna have a mean
of seven we're gonna have a standard
deviation of three
uh when we have 10 we run that we see we
have one still and then with four
we have negative ones too
we could go ahead and add now one extra
row so let's say 32 one
that and this let's run this again and
we see that we have
our normalized data right here which has
been done automatically unlike where we
needed to specify the mean for each and
every column here our normalizer adapts
to our input data so how is all this
related to what we've been doing
yeah all we need to do is uh we've been
given X so we have X recall we're not
doing normalization on the Y obviously
we're doing this on the inputs so we are
having our inputs X we've got an already
so we could print out the shape let's
take this off
we know the shape of x x shape
you see we have
oh
growing that we have a thousand by eight
so we're going to normalize for each of
those eight columns
and instead of struggling to get the
mean and variance for each of those
columns tensorflow payments also adapt
to this our data set so that said we
have that given to us we could just
recopy this oops we have that oh is that
out we have our normalization uh
normalized uh this is actually X so we
don't need to specify this anymore so
here we just adapt to X adapter X
um and that's it let's print out this x
so we see kind of the kind of outputs we
get uh let's say we want to get the
first five elements again so that's it
so what do we see we have that and then
you know X first five elements of first
five rows there we go so here we see we
have this five which is converted to
0.25 we have this 4 to negative 0.232
and so on and so forth so this has been
done automatically and we are now ready
to train our model using this normalized
beater
we've gotten to the point where we're
gonna trade the machine learning model
in our case our model is simply this
straight line right here of the form of
equation y equals m x plus C as you
could see here
we have this inputs X so there we go
inputs X outputs Y and we have our
weights M and C which happens to be this
constant
that said we have an X which gets in
here it gets multiplied by m so we have
a multiplication by m and then we obtain
MX so now we have m x and then it gets
added to C so here we have
multiplication and here we have addition
and this gives us Y which actually
equals MX plus C so let's say it gives
us MX plus C let's take this off we have
m x and then we put all this into a box
which is what we call our model now
notice here let's have this we have our
model we have X get into a model and we
have our output right here
and then what we're trying to do is to
get the most appropriate values for M
and C such that we have an output which
best represents our data set so that's
set
our model could be represented by this
line so we could have a model like this
we could have this we could have this we
see we have so many different
possibilities
and so when we're talking about a model
essentially what we're having is a
function which tries to be
representative of our data set
now this means if let's take this off
this means if we have a model like this
clearly this isn't a very good model
this is a very poor model since it
doesn't actually represent uh it doesn't
embody the data set we have in here and
so a model looking like this will be a
better one
for now we'll just stick to the model
creation but we should note that this
model has to be chosen such that it
represents best uh data set so we're
going to look at this in the error on
management and training and optimization
sections
and before we get there that is before
we see how to get the optimal values for
M and C we are going to create this
model using tensorflow the good news is
tensorflow makes it very easy for us to
create deep learning models so here we
can Define our model
tensorflow.karas dot sequential
so we have that and then uh we pass in a
normalizer
and we have a dance layer so here we
have a dance layer which takes in an
output of one now this dance layer is
actually a Keras layer so let's uh get
in here so from tensorflow that carries
the layers we imported normalization
previously now we import the dense layer
so we have dance we run that again
and right here we have a model modeled
summary
there we go
we could visualize this model
we've just created our first ever model
with tensorflow so let's break all this
down now we have this sequential API
which we use here in creating this model
this is just one out of three different
ways and with models are generally
created with tensorflow we have the
sequential API we have the functional
API and then we have the subclassen
method so that's it for now we'll work
with a sequential API we could look at
the documentation for the sequential API
in the
tensorflow.keras model so right here we
have this sequential click on that and
there we go so basically what this takes
in is just layers
and here we have some examples on how
this is used so that said you could see
we Define a model and then we add layers
to this model so basically we're just
stacking up layers to this model
now this means instead of having this
syntax right here we could instead have
this so we could uh take this off we
take this off we have that and then we
have model dot add uh tf.keras or let's
just say normalizer so we add the
normalizer and then model dot add the
dance layer so we have our dense layer
I'll put one and that's it
um let's run this and we get exactly the
same output we had right here
now let's take this off and get back to
our sequential API so as the word goes
is
the way we build models when layers are
all form a sequence that is
if you're building deep learning models
where the way they are constructed is
such that we have the input we have the
model we have the output and then all
the layers which make up this model uh
simply just
stacked up one layer after another so we
could have this layers which are from
the model we'll look at more complex
layers later but for now let's suppose
we have this kind of model made of
different layers layer one layer two up
to layer n where we just simply stack up
these layers in this way then working
with a sequential API is a good option
now let's take this off let's take uh
this
and then make use of the exact model
we're actually currently dealing with
right here we have this model and we
have this other model
so we have all rather we have this layer
and we have this other layer right here
we have the normalization layer which
we've seen already we understand that
our inputs need to be normalized before
being passed into our dense layer right
here so here we actually have this dense
layer but then this should be the first
time or maybe it's the first time you
get enough this dense layer so we try to
explain what goes on in this dance layer
but you should note that this
model is simply made of the
normalization layer and the dense layer
so without the normalization layer let's
look at how the dense layer works with a
dense layer as you could see here let's
suppose we have an input so we have the
horsepower input
um getting in here we have our input
then in this dance layer we take this
input the horsepower which we call X
multiplied by m and then add a value C
this m happens to be the weight and then
the C is what we call the bias so that
set we have this and then here we have m
x plus C so here's our output which is
actually equals y predicted so let's
call this y predicted
and that's it so uh what do we do now
when we have many variables once we have
many variables we still have our same
dense layer but there's a difference so
here we have this variable let's suppose
we have uh eight variables so we have
one two three
there we go we have this eight variables
now all these get into
our dance layer so we pass this into our
dance layer
then what goes on in this dance layer is
that for each of those inputs we have
this M1 M2
M3 M4 M5 up to M8
and we have this M1
times x so we have m1x similar to what
we had here here we just had one M since
we had one input but now we have M1
times x that's the input here uh let's
say X1 Plus
up to m
8 x 8.
then we add that bias so we add this
bias C right here and then we have plus
C so yes our dense layer right here this
is exactly what goes on in our dense
layer and then we have obviously our
output y predicted so that's it
We Now understand exactly how this dance
layer works now you'll notice that we
have one two three four five six seven
eight weight losses bias making us
nine different parameters
and that's why right here you actually
have this nine params given to you
um you have this non-trainable param 17
this comes from the normalization layer
now as non-trainable simply because
we've already fitted this normalization
layer to our data or we've adapted this
normalization layer to our data so we
don't need to modify the parameters mu
and variance anymore we don't need to
modify the mean of the variance anymore
actually so that's it we understand
exactly what's going on and why we have
nine trainable parameters here so
um from here we should note that where
we construct the dance layer is quite
simple all you need to do is to see how
many outputs do I need to have now in
our case
we just want to Output a current price
and since we want to Output this current
price which is just one value our number
of outputs here equal one so that's why
we pick this number of outputs to be
equal one now if we needed to predict
say two current prices uh maybe we need
to predict the current price now and the
current price in the in the year say 20
30 then we would have output two so
that's it we just have one output that's
why we do that uh from here we have this
model.summary which you can call very
easily and see this kind of interesting
summaries of our model so that's it uh
we now look at how to plot this model
out that's quite easy we have
tensorflow.keras.utils plot model and
now we pass in our model we specify to
file one dot this model out and then uh
generate a file so we just say model.png
show
tips show shapes there we go
um true so we want to show shapes we run
that
we see clearly here we have an input
layer we have our normalization and our
dense layer notice how the inputs and
the output has been specified so this
known here is actually the back
Dimension and since we could treat data
of
any bite size we just have this as known
now what's our batch size
you see our full data set we had right
here
um generally we are not going to load
all this data set at once into our model
as we may be limited by memory
requirements so that's set
while we pass into our model is actually
passing batches so we could work in
batches of two so we could just pass out
just two values or two of this did it
points into our model we could pass just
this two and so on and so forth if our
bite size is say 8 we just pass all this
into our date into our model at once and
then move to the next batch and so on
and so forth but now note that generally
you will not want to have
a very large batch size as this will
lead to a problem known as overfeeding
visual trade subsequently in this course
but for now just note that
working with back sizes of 32 and below
is actually a good idea so let's come
back to our model which we had here We
Now understand why we have this notes
here this actually our batch Dimension
now uh we could also in addition to this
normalizer or before the normalizer
would define an input layer so let's
let's just declare this here uh let's
just add this here let's import this we
have input layer there we go so we have
our input layer which we're going to add
from those Keras layers if you notice
here we just had this known so our
inputs are not specified the input shape
is to specify the output shape not
specified so what if we come and specify
this here we have input layer
input layer
sorry we have this and then we have the
input shape which we could specify so
yeah we have
a shape of the batch by eight so we have
a badge Dimension so if it's 32 we have
32 by 8 so this is what's getting to our
model at once and not maybe the whole
thousand samples we have so instead of
sending all this we send just
a batch of 32. now uh when creating this
input layer since obviously uh up front
we don't know the exact back size we'll
take this off and just have that so we
just have this shape we pass that
we have this error let's add a comma and
we also uh have to know that this is a
list we're passing it so we have this
first element of the list this next
element on this other element and I will
do this I will use the model dot add
option which we saw already so we run
this
let's have this year and there we go so
we see we have exactly the same kind of
responses previously and then let's run
this again so we'll see this difference
now you notice that we don't have none
again here now we know exactly the shape
of our inputs so that said we could now
get straight away to the next section
which is that of error sanctioning
so at this point we've um had our built
a model as you could see y equals MX
plus C and
we'll now see how to know how well
or how representative this model is of
our data set so to check this out you'll
notice that for each and every output we
have so supposing we have this points
right here we are going to compare
the actual
output with what the model gives us so
our model tells us that at this point so
we add this x this is x axis at this
points right here
we should have or what our model
tells us is we should have this output
at this so this is our selling price I
cut into the model but then what we
actually have is this so what comes from
our data set or the actual selling price
is at this point if you look at the sort
of points right here you'll see that our
model does quite well as our model
or the actual price is this and if we
extrapolate we see our model tells us
our price is this so the actual price
and the models price is quite similar
now if you take another Point like this
you see this performs polyure our model
tells us we should be around this
selling price and the actual selling
prices around this so this tells us that
if we want to choose the best possible
values for M and C then we have to
choose them such that we minimize these
differences so there's differences we
have here that's this is what the model
gives so we have to try to minimize
these differences by minimizing the
differences we actually sanction in this
error so we're sanctioning the model
every time it makes these kinds of
Errors so with this kind of uh large
errors we have here we're trying to
sanction the model
and then when we kind of like work
perfectly like this
our model receives less sanction or in a
case where it's actually perfect our
model received no sanction
that said this section is actually quite
simple like oh what we'll do is
when you have an error or simply let's
say we have an output so we have this
error but uh the way we calculate this
error was we have an output and then we
have the all right that we have the
actual output and we have the models
predicted output so we have the actual
output here let's call it y a and then
we have y bread so this is what our
model produced right here now what we
could do is we'd subtract this two and
then we Square this
and you'll see clearly that if the Y
actual and the Y predicted are both the
same then in that case we'll have zero
because y a y pet is the same so why a
minus y pair is zero and if we have zero
it means we are having to give that
model a zero sanction for that
particular prediction like uh in this
case right here now if there's a very
great difference between these two then
we are subtracting it and also squaring
so you see clearly that if you have
maybe two and four so if our actual is
four and what the model produces two
then two minus four we would have
already four minus two anyway actually
because we are going to square this so
we have four minus two we're going to
give us two and if we're just y Prime
minus y a would have two but now we're
squaring this so we have two square so
we now have four so we're squaring this
errors so and inside will make an error
we amplify that error
now if we want to get the overall error
we could use what we call the mean
square error function
would mean square error function what
we're basically doing is this but we're
repeating this for each and every point
and then we find in the average of all
those errors
and as usual tensorflow already has this
built in so all we need to do is just
make use of this function which has
already been built here we have our loss
function you notice that it's under the
tensorflow.keras TF dot Keras let's roll
up here we have tear the Keras with
single sequential now we're looking at
the losses so yeah we have this losses
we could also check in those layers here
and you'll see that we have our dense
layer so
we start to understand
how this
TF dot Keras section here is structured
so here we have our dance layer which
we've seen already the number of output
units we're going to look at all this
subsequently so now let's close this and
get back to our mean square error so
here we have losses
um squared error
that's it
um
there we go we have here some examples
so we could look at this why true that's
why actual on the Y predicted by our
model now or during the mean square
error here
we have zero minus one that's one one
square is one one minus one zero we have
one plus zero plus one obviously zero
minus one is one is negative one
negative one square is one so for now we
have one plus one because zero minus
zero is zero so when we will add up all
this we have one plus one that gives us
two now how many different elements we
have we have four elements so two
divided by four it gives us 0.5 so we've
summed up all these Square errors and
then we divide by the total number of
elements we have which in this case is
four so that's exactly how we obtain the
0.5
now we have that we just simply come
right here and then we have from
tensorflow that caress the losses we're
gonna import our mean
squared error so that's it let's run
that
that's fine and we could make use of
this mean square error now uh the way we
make use of this is actually when we're
compiling our model so we have
model.compile
and we Define our loss so our loss is a
mean square error which we've just
defined mean square error that's it and
what does
does is as we compile in our model we
can take into consideration the fact
that our error sanctioning function is
going to be the mean squared error
now for regression tasks apart from the
mean square error we also have the mean
absolute error
and here every time we do the
subtraction of the Y true that's why
actual on the Y I predicted instead of
squaring this what we do is we'll
calculate the absolute value so it's
quite similar to what we've seen already
with the mean square error just the the
only difference here is we have the
absolute of the subtraction of the
difference between the actual and the
predicted value of y
to better understand when to use
the mean square error or the mean
average error already the mean absolute
error let's take this example you see
with this example we have the horsepower
and the current price
most times the horsepower is
positively correlated to the current
price that is if we increase the
horsepower generally or overall we have
an increase in the current price and for
a reduces the horsepower we have an
overall
reducing the current price now we may
have this point here which is actually
what we call an outlier we see that we
have a very high horsepower but the
price is very low
and in the case where we're using the
mean square error we'll be having y
minus y this y a or let's say y yeah y
actual and then y print so we have y
actual minus y prepared and then we're
going to square all this you see that
this is just one or is
kind of like a minority in our data set
and when
modifying the weights of our model we
don't want this to weigh too much or to
have so much priority
in the way we choose the values for M
and C
and so that said
using a loss function like this which
actually squares this errors is not a
good idea because
since this error here is going to be
very large so uh if we continue with
this and around this let's suppose let's
suppose around this so our model at this
uh this x our model will break something
like this will be around this and then
uh the actual Beyond this so we have
this large Arrow squaring this large
area again gives us a very large value
and so this will
have very much to say when we're picking
out this values for M and C as basically
we modifying those values based on this
error So based on the error we're trying
to modify the values such that we pick
the values which minimize this error
actually
and as we've said in the case of the
mean square error for this kind of
outliers we
making them too important when we should
focus more on these other
data points
now with the mean average error would
mean absolute error we have Y A minus y
p and we compute the absolute value now
here clearly we understand that
our overall loss or the loss we get with
these kinds of outliers is reduced
compared to this since yeah we just
simply finding the absolute value on
like year where we're squaring and so in
uh working with data sets where we have
outliers like this is preferable to use
the mean absolute error now there is a
loss function known as a u by loss which
actually
permits us make use of this mean square
error and I mean absolute error in a
more intelligent manner that is when we
have an outlier we are going to use a
mean absolute error but when we have a
normal data point we use the mean Square
Arrow by normal data point
we mean a point where the Y true minus
the Y bread which here is this x isn't
uh is less than a given threshold
and by an outlier we're talking about
points where the Y2 minus white bread is
greater than the certain threshold so
here we have the definition for the Uber
loss we see how this x x actually Y2
minus yep so when Computing the Uber
loss if we have this condition we use
this variance of the mean square error
where we have 0.5 times this y true
minus y red square and then when is
greater than D so here we're dealing
with outliers that's these are threshold
when we're dealing with our Liars we
have 0.5 times D Squared that's times
this difference squared plus
uh this D times the absolute value of
y true minus y Prime minus D so there's
a formula the hubris formula again we
don't need to
rewrite all the subscribed since we have
this with tensorflow so that's that all
we need to Define here is our Delta
which is that threshold
that defines whether it data point is an
outlier or not so here again we have our
losses we have the Uber loss and then we
have the mean
average or rather than mean absolute
error
this is actually Uber simply so we run
that
there we go so here we here we're going
to compile our model let's take this we
have the mean Square
we have the mean absolute
and we could also have the Uber so if we
run this you see your model compiles you
could just simply specify Uber
but we need to pass in our Delta so
we're running this
way using the default Delta which was
given to us if we want to specify our
own Delta we just specify that way so we
could take 0.2 and stuff like that so
here we have oh the default data is
actually is one so that's it
um let's take this off we're gonna be
using the mean
the mean absolute error
now note that with machine learning we
do a lot of experiments so after we're
gonna train our model we're gonna
measure its performance and so if you
measure the performance and you see that
it isn't good enough you could come and
modify the error
functioning using so you could change
the mean absolute error we're about to
use to mean square error or maybe to the
Uber loss and from there you try to see
which loss functions permit you
get the best possible performance for
your model
from here we move on to training
optimization recall our model was linear
function which we're trying to
feet such that this year this m and this
X or rather this m under C
right here
are peaked so that this errors here are
minimized so just looking at this we
could have another line drawn here we're
gonna have this line we could have this
other line so we could add to the line
and so many on infinite possibility of
or an infinite number of possible lines
we could generate
and so in order to get this m and C what
we use uh
the method commonly used today is
stochastic gradient descent now let's
understand how this works uh we'll just
use this or write this out in this one
formula we have a weight
which has to be updated recall that uh
initially our weights are random so we
randomly initialize our weights so this
means here that if we randomly
initialize M and c and then let's
suppose we we have uh M to be zero so we
have M 0 and then let's say C is one
then in that case we would have
something like this we would have a line
like this and it's clear that this line
isn't
very representative of this data we have
here and so what we could do now is to
update this m and C such that the take
up values which permit us
adapt to this data set which we've been
given and the way it has done as we've
said already is with the sdd algorithm
and this is how it goes so we have
a weight so we have a weight previous so
we have the previous weight or in the
case where where the first step we have
the initialized or randomly initialized
weights minus
um a learning rate so we have a learning
rate the rate at which we're learning
this
data which we've been given times the
derivative now in case you have no
background in calculus you shouldn't
have
any worries as tensorflow will take care
of this so here we have learning rate
times uh this derivative of the loss
function with respect to that weight
so yeah we have the weight previous so
that said uh if initially we have zero
and then here we have C uh let's say c
as we said the radius two now what
happens is for each and every weight
we're gonna take this so we we want to
get the new values for the weight or for
m so we have M it's going to be equals
it's initial value is zero so the
previous value is zero minus now let's
pick a linear rate generally random
rates are picked in the order of
0.001 0.1
0.01
0.0001 and you could continue to one
times ten to the say negative six
so yeah we're supposing we've picked 0.1
and now we have
0.1 so that's our learning rate times
the derivative of the loss now what's
the loss recall we have
already seen three loss functions in our
error management section so here we are
having 0.1 times
the rate at which the loss changes with
respect to that particular weight so we
have 0.1 times this
we respect to m
and the same is done for C so we're
gonna do two minus our same linear rate
times DL on DC
we have now updated M and c and then now
if we compute the error we would have y
actual minus this new values of M and C
are going to be used here so we're going
to have our new M times X plus our new C
and we compute a new error so we'll have
a new error
and so from here we expect that as we
keep on training so as we keep on
training we want our loss to keep
dropping up to say a value of zero since
we want to have zero loss though in this
case we see clearly that it's not
possible for us to
use just a straight line
and obtain a loss of zero since we
cannot pass through each and every point
with a straight line
so if we're able to build this kind of
model then we would have a loss of zero
since for each and every point the
actual
output is the same as our predicted
output and so we'll obviously have zero
loss
but with a straight line that's not
possible
so as a recap we see that we have our
inputs and we have our outputs we have m
and C that's our model parameters we
pass our inputs using our initialize M
and C we get outputs we compute the loss
as we compute the difference between
what are we actually supposed to get and
what our model predicts we get this
difference we could use a square or just
absolute value function we
get this loss and based on this loss we
modify this values and then we repeat
the same process to our training
converges our training converges simply
means we've attained a point where our
loss doesn't increase anymore so if we
have training like this we could get to
this point to see at this a certain
point uh we keep on training that is we
keep on repeating the within descent
step which we've seen already where we
update by doing W
equals W
minus a learning rate
times d l over DW so we repeat the step
which I've seen already and
if our loss doesn't change much or
doesn't even change at all
then our model has converged and we
could stop training at that point
as usual tensorflow does all the hard
work for us and so here we have model of
feet we pass in our X that's our inputs
X Y we specify the number of epochs uh
let's say 100 verbose equals one now we
understand what this x and y means so
basically our data set now the ebooks or
the number of epochs here is specified
the number of times we are going to
update our weights so number of times we
are going to go through the gradient
descent step and for variables which it
has to do with the
outputs from our training step so here
we've run we've compiled
let's correct this we have okay so we
have that we compile that's fine and we
run this you see because our variable is
equal one we are able to get these kinds
of outputs so here we're going to see in
real time uh the values of our loss
um let's stop this so we'll stop that
and then we send variables to zero
you'll notice that as the training goes
on we don't get to see those uh loss
values anymore so let's
take this back stop this
you see variables equal one now we're
able to see a lot so as we go from one
Epoch to another we're able to get the
mean absolute errors that's the total
mean absolute error which is an absolute
value of our
model predictions or the absolute value
of the difference between our model
predictions and the actual current
prices when we get into this tier that
carries on model
documentation and we go to compile you
see we could have this right here we
have the definition of compile we see
how by default our Optimizer is RMS prop
now note that
this Optimizer or the different
optimizers uh essentially variants of
the stochastic gradient descent
algorithm so here we get into Optimizer
as you can see we have either Delta or
the grad atom and yeah we see you have
SGD so this is the SGD we've seen
already right here so we can have this
sdd we specify the learning rate at this
point we understand what learning means
we have the momentum we could increase
this parameter so that we could speed up
training and we could also specify
whether we're having a nester of type
momentum right here so when we see
enough to rough true then we're having
an srf type momentum so that's it
um
of all these optimizers the most
commonly used is the Adam Optimizer so
you'll see
that made his hand is some practitioners
generally use this Optimizer but default
the learning rate is
0.001 beta 1 0.9 beta 2 0.999 Epsilon or
1 times 10 to the negative seven
and the AMS graph type is set to false
to better understand the learning rate
let's take this example so here we have
lost versus weights like the M or the C
and now we have the derivative of the
loss with respect to the weight so let's
consider that this derivative is
positive so let's pick a point like this
we have the weight uh here yes this
particular weight let's say w I picked
out this point and we have this
derivative of the last respect to the
weight or the partial derivative
actually and then we have uh let's say
we have the slope so the slope is
positive
to update this weight from wi to a new
weight we apply this formula so we have
w i minus a learning rate times this
positive slope
now if this learning rate is too small
let's say 10 to the power of negative 10
so we have a very small learning rate
it's clear that we are not going to have
a great difference between the w we
obtained after this update since this is
going to
be multiplied by this positive value and
W minus a very small number will give us
a value very close to W so there's not
going to be a very great change after
this update we're going to have a very
small change actually smaller than this
now if uh L R does a learning rate is
too large let's say we take a learning
rate of 10 to the power of three in that
case we have W minus a thousand times
this positive value then the change is
going to be to
brutal and instead of say going slowly
towards this
points we are going to actually skip
that point and get to this other point
right here
and if we keep doing this we actually go
away from this point so we we're picking
up points which are far away from this
point now why is this point important
this point is important because at this
point as we could see here the last
is minimal so uh record that as the aim
of this error uh sanctioning section
well we're trying to minimize the loss
that said many times by default or
from many experiments starting out with
0.001 is going to be a good idea but
note that you could always change this
so you could feel free to change this
you could take something bigger recall
that if you take a bigger value your
training is going to be faster risks
diversion that is risk
not leading you towards that minimal
loss whereas if you take it too small
then you would converge but your
training is going to take too much time
so this value is kind of a great or one
that's very commonly used now
particularly for this Adam Optimizer we
have this parameter Speedo one and beta2
now your beta one uh Max and beta 2 max
are are one so taking a value like 0.9
and 0.99 year means we're taking High
values of beta 1 and beta 2. if you want
to speed up training you want to
increase the values for beta 1 and B to
two by default this values are set to
0.9 0.99
now when doing or carrying out
computations with respect to the Adam
Optimizer we're trying to avoid dividing
by zeros so we have this Epsilon
parameter here which is uh by default
one times ten to the negative seven now
if we want the AMS Grant uh variance of
the item Optimizer you could set this to
true so that's it
we now have from tensorflow dot Keras
dot optimizers uh we're gonna import
Adam so we've imparted that that's fine
uh now we're gonna make use of that so
actually in this compile we have
Optimizer equals Adam and that's it so
we'll Define our Optimizer and we'll
Define the loss so let's run this again
we actually had an arrow so let's take
this item run that
that's fine and there we go
now we've been getting these values for
loss what if we start this in a variable
so we could have history equal model of
feet so this time around after doing the
training will be able to recall all the
slots values we got during training
there we go we have history dot history
we run that
and yeah we got all our lost values
let's climb up and you see here we have
this dictionary we have loss and then we
have this list of all the Lost values
we now import map.lib so
we now paste this out here we specify
this plot we have history.history which
we've seen already and we specify the
loss because this is actually a
dictionary we'll pick the loss uh we
specify the title y label X level The
Legend and then we show this plot
so this is what we get right here we see
how we drop our loss value is dropping
but the waiter which is dropping is
actually quite small so what if we speed
up the training by modifying the
learning rate so right here we have
learning rates
equal
0.1 uh let's just pick a linear rate of
one and run that
we run this and we see that the loss
actually drops faster this time around
from here we move on to Performance
measurement we actually measuring how
well this model performs
and one common function used in
regression problems like this is the
root mean square error
you should note that it's not in every
case where you would have the
performance measurement function similar
to that of the loss as this two actually
quite different concepts for the
performance measurement
uh making use of the performance
measurement we are able to see whether
these two models so supposing we have
two models model one and model two
have the same performance or do
have different performance and which of
them are performs the order so
um if we run performance measurement
we'll be able to see whether model one
or performs model 2 or model one under
performance model 2.
that said we could include this metric
in here so we have the optimizer loss
and the metric so we have this root mean
square error metric which has been added
and which has already been imported so
imported this year note that this is a
metric not uh loss so we have this
Matrix with important root mean square
error and if that's fine
we could go ahead compile and start our
training again
now you will notice that both the loss
and the root mean Square errors are
being printed out so this is what we
could see now
after the training will be done we'll be
able to plug this two out so here we
have the last
you can see we run the loss and we have
the rooting squared Arrow so this is uh
what we are putting to get this exact uh
string right here you could do history
dot history
so here we have the history
and you would see that
okay here you have the last
so we have the first uh key loss oh then
we have this list of all losses and then
we have the next root mean squared error
and then we have this list made of all
the wooden Square Arrow values so that's
what we that's how we get that uh We've
plotted it out and this is what we have
another
um
method which comes with tensorflow
models is the evaluate method so here we
could have model.evaluate and we simply
pass an X and Y so we evaluate our model
this way so you see uh We've evaluated
our model
and we have the models loss and the root
mean squared Arrow
from here we move to validation and
testing to better understand validation
and testing let's take a simple example
imagine you get into class that is you
get a class on the first day
um and you have been taught some course
materials so you've been taught this
course materials throughout the whole
term or say the whole semester
and then at the end of the semester
the teacher always feeling lazy tells
each and every student to feel free to
produce their own exam and after
producing this exam they should sit for
this exam produced by themselves so they
could feel free to come up with any kind
of question uh sit for this exam and
after sitting for this exam uh the Mac
your scripts by themselves it's clear
that uh most students will have Max or
greater than say 18 and 20 and this is
simply because this exam has been set by
the students themselves
now it may happen that a student has
followed through the coursework and
mastered everything and then set real
questions or tough questions and got
this Mark of 18. same as other students
may not have terribly gone through this
cause work and uh produce very easy
questions which will get them a mark of
greater than 18 without any much effort
or without mastering the coursework
and so that's why the strategy is very
dangerous as we need that
um
external validation
from uh
teacher and so far what we've been doing
here is kind of like the first method
where each and every student produces
the exams writes sees for the exams and
then marks their exams by themselves and
that's simply because here we're using
our full data set
train on this full data set and
evaluating this performance
without taking into consideration better
that the model has never seen so the
idea is to be able to create a model
that when it sees new theater is able to
come up with a reasonable current price
which
is as close as possible to the actual
current price
and so when dealing with machine
learning models is important to say
break a data set into two parts so if
you have uh like in the example we're
working on a 1000 examples you could
break this up search that you have eight
other examples which you train your
model on and then you could test that
model on another 200 examples so here
we've never or the model has never
seen this
part of your data set right here and
this is one very important use of the
shuffling because with the shuffling we
are sure that
there is no bias in the way the data set
is is constituted as now if we just
break this up we have oh
one part for testing another part for
training
which has been randomly built
and so as we're saying if a model for
example has a performance of say
um
root mean Square value
equals let's take um say five
uh on the training data so on this
training data and then on the test data
it has a root mean Square value of
50 000
then it's clear that this is a very poor
performing model as it does well on only
on data it has seen But on data it
hasn't yet seen it doesn't perform well
and so recall machine learning is all
about empowering the machine to do stuff
humans and room to do and obviously
humans use some intelligence in doing
all those tasks so if you want to build
a model you have to ensure that it
performs well on theater it has never
seen and so we always have to split our
data set so firstly we Shuffle our data
set very important we split this data
set
before proceeding with modeling and
training
now sometimes we don't want to wait
until our model has trained before
testing it out and discovering that it
performs very poorly on data is never
seen so what we want to do is while
doing the training we want to be able to
see how it performs on data it has not
seen and that's why we have a validation
set so that's why you need a validation
set we'll see now we'll need to test and
set as you can see here and then now we
need a validation set
and that said yeah we could reduce our
training 600 and then we increase this
so we have 200 so we have our data set
of a thousand little points which is
broken up now into our training
validation and testing now note that if
you have a data set of say let's
increase this
of this how many this is a hundred if
you have a hundred million data points
then
um taking for example like previously we
we chose this two this is actually sixty
percent twenty percent twenty percent
but if we have a hundred million data
points we could always use ninety
percent here
um here we could use five percent and
yeah we could use five percent reason
being that uh since the total data set
is very large
um getting five percent of a very large
number is already quite a huge number of
samples so that is good enough for us to
build our validation and testing sets we
get back to our data set preparation
let's include the cell here we specify
our training and validation or training
validation and test ratios so we're
gonna use eighty percent of our total
data for training or ten percent for
validation and ten percent for testing
um the data set size we have a year the
land of X is a thousand
and we run this we added a
called cell actually right here at this
then we have this extreme white train
made of elements in the top eighty
percent position as here we have data
set size so if you have 1000 times this
ratio give us 800 and we have the first
800 elements same with this
um we print out the
extreme shape and we could do same for y
train so that's it we have this
shape right here so that's it we have uh
broken this up a thousand now we have a
hundred let's do same so let's add this
and do same now for the validation so
instead of training we have Val
and down here we have Val so we have
vowel and now we want the next 10 so
what we're gonna do here is we simply
copy this
that's it
um here we have the validation ratio
all rather we have we're going from the
train ratio actually
so we have the train ratio up to the
train ratio
plus the validation ratio because we're
going from 0.8 now to 0.9
um that said we would have this
Plus
the validation
ratio
so that's fine next we let's just copy
this so we've copied this
there we go take this off
we get the next values
so that's it we've gotten this next
values uh we have X right here we have X
Val
X Val and your X vowel so we run that
um
let's close this right here so we have
this we run it that's fine okay so now
we have the next uh next hundred and
and then we now get the last hundred so
since we have no other section we just
all we need to do is just um specify
this
specify this still validation actually
but right up to the end so we have that
we run it and there we go we have the
data set which has been split into the
training validation and testing we have
extreme y train X1 y vowel
um yeah we have extends this should be X
test so let's change this X test X test
X test okay so we run that and that's
fine
now one important point to notice you
have to avoid information leaking from
the training into the validation and the
testing so this means
even when doing normalization and you
tend to adapt your normalizer to your
data you have to not use the validation
and testing you just have to use the
training so here we're gonna use only
the training set to adapt our normalizer
to our theater
from here we have to modify the way we
do our training so here we just have to
specify that we have extreme we have y
train and then our validation
bitter is equal
[Music]
we have this x vowel and y vowel so
that's it so here we specify x value y
valency validation data and then you
have extreme y train as your training
Theater now note that uh when doing this
so
um with a validation data
you actually specify x value y vowel but
there is another argument which is the
validation split where you just specify
the fraction of the training data to be
used as validation data
so again here as usual you could go
through this documentation you see you
have shuffling which you could do but
which we've done already you have all
these are arguments which you could
check out in this documentation getting
back to the code we run this we run our
training
Now train is done you could notice how
we have this extra
um outputs here the validation root mean
squared error and the validation loss so
you could see you notice this right here
let's get straight away and to put into
spots
again let's do history let's add this so
here history the history
[Music]
and here we see we have the validation
loss
um go up we have the room in square
error we should we should get the
validation rooting square error so let's
scroll down
there we go we have the validation root
mean Square Arrow
just right here so now we have uh the
training and validation which has been
outputted during training process recall
the use of the validation is for us to
be able to see during training how well
our model performs on later it is never
ever seen before
so let's go ahead and do some plotting
here we have our loss uh
uh we have this right here
we specify the validation loss
there we go let's run that okay so we
see our validation and training last
Let's uh this year we have loss so we
specify the legend okay there we go we
have our training dealer and we have our
validation data we see that our
validation data our model does better on
our validation data actually yes we have
lower
lost values for the validation data we
could repeat the same process with the
root mean Square Arrow so here we have
that
there we go we now put in your
validation so here we have validation
and then we have validation we run that
and it's kind of like similar here the
validation of those better or the model
does better on our validation set from
this point let's take this off
we get back to model evaluate so let's
evaluate our model
by just specifying this wouldn't help so
uh you could actually put this x value y
Val so no we're not evaluating anymore
on our training data but now the
validation data and we could also now
evaluate on our test data recall our
validation was
um used during training we saw how it
performed during training now we're
gonna evaluate our model on dealer it is
never seen so we evaluated on our test
data and this is what we get we see we
have this loss and this root mean square
error value
at this point we'll train our data or
we've trained our model on our data and
we can get to that long-awaited part
that is testing our model so here we are
not just uh evaluating a model or doing
some validation but we are passing in
theater and then we're allowing our
model to predict the car price for us so
that said uh let's get straight away
into that we have X test which we know
already well which we built already
um that is it extend the shape there we
go
um
let's pick out a value from this X test
let's just say x that's zero so what we
do is model dot predict so now we've
trained our model we now do model dot
predict and we pass in X test so here we
don't need to pass y test we'll just
pass X test so here we pass X test and
our model should predict
the car price for us now passing an X
test uh we have all these predictions so
because we have a hundred you see shape
um there we go we have a hundred
different elements so for each and every
uh data point of for each and every
input in our testing set we have all
these outputs let's just pick out a few
let's say we want just the first so
that's it
um there is one which is normal because
the input shape here has to be of type
uh batch size by eight but here we're
sending this uh shape eight so we should
do expand themes uh in case you
understand this well let me repeat again
or let me just do this test zero that
shape that's a shape
you see that's the zero shape now X
that's the shape
that's the shape now this model as we
defined previously you know input right
here you know input takes in uh by size
by eight so here we have to ensure that
if we're passing in any ditter it has to
be of the shape
so now we have uh put in this and what
we need to do is to expand them such
that we'll leave from uh the shape eight
to the shape one eight so that it takes
this form and when is like this it means
our buy size is one so that said let's
do expand themes we've seen this in the
previous section we have expand themes
there we go uh we add this axis
equals zero
that's fine
um and we run that so that's it
everything works fine now let's take
this off we run that again and we have
our response so this tells us that for
our first uh point in our data set or
first input
our car price prediction is this now oh
this is
very interesting to view but what if we
compare this with what the uh model or
what the data already presented to us
because we extremely label this as test
but we know the actual values so we know
the actual car price and what if we
compare it with this predicted car price
so that said let's look at why
test zero
and check out this value so here we have
a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
and here we're predicting eleven
thousand nine hundred and forty dollars
so clearly our model is performing very
poorly
to visually understand this pro model
performance we are going to plot a bar
chart
showing the predicted and True Values
shown side by side
um let's take this to say 20
and there we go as you could see right
here let's scroll okay that's fine as
you could see we have this blue which is
for the predicted and then the orange
father
actual values of Y
so we have the president and the actual
prizes which are shown to us now
the way we put this out is quite simple
we have uh we Define the way of the
figure size uh we have this bar so here
we pronounce some bar charts and
we're specifying the position of each
element with respect to the bar chart
now this in here if we plot this out so
print out uh we also use numpy to get
this so let's run that
and you see that this is a least
comparison of value from 0 to 99 so uh
these parameters get uh the position for
each and every element so we have a
hundred different positions and then uh
the width obviously this player uh let's
reduce the weight so you understand that
we see that visually let's take this
let's increase it to one so we've
increased the width you see this becomes
very large now let's take that back uh
let's see 0.1
you have this you see it becomes very
thin and that's it so we could uh play
around with the width now once we fix a
position say we fixed this position we
now move which steps further so that's
what we do and oh we have then passed in
here we have the level X level y level
and then we plot that out so that's how
we come up with this plot
which shows clearly that our model is
performing very poorly
this takes us to our next section on
corrective measures
this poor model performance actually has
a name it's called under fitting so when
you're training loss looks like this and
your validation loss normally validation
loss should be
above the training loss spend some cases
like as we just saw it was uh below the
training loss so we have our validation
so let's say we have our training and
then we have our validation losses which
are like this and
even after training for a long period of
time or for so many epochs we are not
able to go below a certain threshold
this is known as under feeding
and the idea here is to bring this loss
values
like this so we want to modify our model
so that we could have better loss values
that's we could reduce our loss values
as much as we can
that said in order to do this it suffice
us to make our model more complex for
now the model we're having is like this
so here we're having this simple
regression model where we have our
inputs right here M1 M2 f2m 8r weights
and then our bias C we add this up and
then we have our output so what if we
don't we take this off
and then we add up more
neurons right here so instead of just
having one we're gonna stack up more
neurons but they are doing basically the
same thing so kind of like repeating the
same process here so we're gonna have
this link to this this one link to this
the same way is linked to this uh one we
had previously this link to this and so
on and so forth and then we put the same
process for this link then from here so
here we have uh this dense layer from
here again we could
add more than Slayer so this is what we
call a hidden layer here we have a
hidden layer we add more so here we
could have one
and you see here all these are all
linked up this way and it's actually the
same operation
MX plus C so basically we're taking this
weight times this plus uh buyers and
then we get in this we take this times
its weight
um and we get this plus the bias we have
this and then we continue the same
operation so we have this stacked again
we have the first hidden layer in layer
one in Layer Two and uh we could even go
to another one again so let's add this
to here let's add this other hidden
layer let's do this
there we go we've created this third
hidden layer so here we have our inputs
and we have three hidden layers
and obviously since we just producing a
single price from here we could have
this so we now have this uh our output
layer here so input output and then
hidden layers
um
yeah we have this
so we have this dense layer and we have
also this dance layer
um let's try to write out or sketch out
some tensorflow code here so basically
we're going to have dance so we have a
dense layer
right here and what does it output that
is this first dance layer has three
outputs basically Homer and then we move
to the next dance layer so if I have no
list we have this dense layer right here
three outputs unlike the previous one
which has just one output now we have
this dense layer with the output we
stack the next things layer so we see
the way it's easy to carry out all these
operations with tensorflow we start the
next layer with four so we have four
outputs
and then the next we have two outputs
and then finally we have one apple it's
very important to ensure that you have
just one output because that is
kind of like
um matching up with our data we have at
hand so here we have one output and we
put this list so we could put this in
bracket and then have the sequential and
all of that and then you have this so
that's it we have uh seen how we'll
create this very easily with tensorflow
and there is one point we need to
mention that's the activation functions
now activation functions simply put a
non-linear functions
which add even more complexity to the
model you saw how previously we had uh
these inputs and then we had this one
output and we were linked linking them
up like this now we've made this model
more complicated we've added more hidden
layers so that we could learn more
complex
information starting our data set now
another thing we could do is add in the
activation functions as I've said
already and make
this model even more complex common
activation functions are the sigmoid
activation function the tange activation
function the relu activation function
rectified linear unit and the Leaky relu
so we could have this relu that is when
X is greater than zero we maintain X
that is X Remains the Same or the output
equals the input but when X is less than
zero the output becomes zero now here
when X is greater than zero the output
is the same when X is less than zero the
output is negative uh certain Alpha
times x
hence the term leaky as Alpha is
generally a very small number so if we
have 0.1 we could have negative 0.1 x
which is kind of like
um
giving us very small outputs which are
kind of close
to zero now we have the sigmoid
activation function 1 divided by 1 plus
e to the negative x c looks like this
the tangent e to the x minus E to the
negative x divided by E to X Plus e to
the negative X
for now we're going to use this real
activation function and you'll see
subsequently that
all these activation functions could be
gone from tensorflow
Keras activations now you should also
note that if we were to apply for
example the sigma activation function
right here
what will those just after summing up or
just after multiplying this weight by
the inputs and getting the outputs
once we have this we are going to do
sigmoid of this
so we do sigmoid so actually for at each
and every neuron right here we have the
sigmoid of this
so here we have sigmoid of all
computations or the output of the
computations here we have Sigma here we
have sigmoid and in the case in this
layer we have the sigma then for each
and every neuron we have sigmoid if here
we have for example relu then for each
and every neuron we have the relu
activation we now have all that's needed
to make our model perform better and
stop under feeding and so we come right
up here we have a dense layer now let's
say we have 32 so our output will be 32
neurons and then from this we have 32
again and then we stack up another one
and finally we have this layer right
here recall that
we've added up this other dense layers
but at the output we need to have just
one neuron so it's important to ensure
that our output here is one we now
specify the activation so we have
activation equal relu and yeah we'll do
the same for our output here we are not
going to specify any activation because
we don't want to interfere in the way uh
model
comes up with its outputs
that said we could run this
and to make our model even more
complicated we could increase its value
so we could take this to say 128 let's
run that again you see that we have many
more parameters we are training on again
we are still having the 17 non-trainable
parameters so uh when we had this well
we had this
you see we have 17 and 9 trainable now
that we have this we see the number of
trainable parameters
um increases while the non-trainable
parameters remain on the same spot we
have the 17 non-trainable parameters
which is logical since our normalizer
Remains the Same now that said we've
done that we could go to our model so we
see this plot right here that's
clear plot to see how we live from the
input to this dense layer see see here
known by eight none by 128 this next
dense layer this other dance layer and
finally this dense layer
um from there we compile our model let's
take this so here we have 0.1
let's run this and we're ready to fit
our model so let's run that
we now notice how this loss right here
is a smaller order of magnitude as
compared to what we had previously
notice how this uh drops from a hundred
thousand about 144 000 and goes down to
like thirty thousand so uh that's it for
the streaming we now go ahead and
view our plots so there we go we see we
have totally different plot now we live
from this and then we actually drop to
about thirty thousand
also notice how this time around we have
a validation loss which is
higher than that of the training and
this is normal because obviously the
model was trained on the training data
so it will turn to perform better than
uh data it wasn't trained on
now if a model performs very very well
on the training dealer and doesn't
perform
well on the validation then we have a
problem which is known as overfeeding
and we're going to trade this in
subsequent sections so for now we just
continue we plot out the root mean
squared error uh notice uh recall how we
used to have values of this order 334
000 but now we're around 30 000. okay
let's run this what do we have okay so
we have something very similar to the
mean average error that's our loss
that's fine we evaluate our model so
that's it we have uh this last for our
model on our test data so here's our
loss on the test data here's our admin
square error
um from there that's fine okay we do
this white bread
and here's what we now obtain we notice
how this model performs
way better than that previous smaller
model
and as you could see here for this
particular test data point you see our
what our model predicts is exactly the
actual current price
our model isn't perfect but it's doing
quite well at this point we've taken up
some creative measures and our model now
performs better what if we
look at how to load our model even
faster and more efficiently
this can be done thanks to the
tensorflow data API so right here you
have tf.didder you could go to the other
View
and then for now we check on this data
set right here this class is made of
many methods so you have these different
methods here for now we'll start with
the from tensor slices method so from
here we're going to adapt our code to
use tensorflow's leader API
in order for us to gain from all the
advantages that come with it now note
that when you're working with a data set
of say a thousand elements uh you
wouldn't see or you wouldn't
clearly notice the advantage of using
this data API but as you data set gets
larger it becomes
very important to master how to use this
API now that said we are going to
redefine our extreme so yeah we're going
to say train data set train data set and
we're gonna have tf.didder the dataset
Dot from tensor slices so that's it now
we're gonna have this
Tuple which we create and then we pass
in extreme and Y train so that's it now
we've gotten this the next thing we're
gonna do is we're gonna
Shuffle our daily set now we've already
done shuffling
but in the case where shuffling wasn't
done previously you could uh do the
shuffling very easily now so here we
have this that shuffle and we specify a
buffer size uh buffer size let's say
eight
and let's see exactly what this buffer
size actually means so here we have a
seed and you have reshuffled each after
each iteration now let's look at how
this buffer size uh what it means
exactly so here we have been told if you
did a set contains ten thousand elements
but both the sizes set to a thousand
then Shuffle will initially select a
random element from only this first 1000
elements so it's just like saying I'm
picking this first 1000 elements and
I want to carry out my shuffling
only in from this first 1000 elements
such that when I'm picking a random
value obviously when we're doing
shuffling we're picking out random
values in a random order so when I'm
picking up my random value I'm gonna
pick it up from this uh first 1000
values then uh as I said here this once
this element is selected it's based in
this buffer is replaced by the next 1000
uh first element so
um if you have a data set like this with
one two three four five six elements and
then uh we want to shuffle with a buffer
size of three in this case uh we'll
initially select or pick up a random
value from this year from this buffer
from this first three elements and then
if suppose we pick this uh random value
right here what we'll do let's let's
take this let's annotate this one two
three
uh four
five and six so if we've picked up two
we've picked up two now we're gonna have
our next buffer
to be like this we're gonna now have one
three and four so this next element is
going to be added to our buffer and then
we'll have this five six
five six right here
and once we're done with this so once we
pick up another random number let's say
we pick up four we pick up four here our
next buffer will be one three five so we
have one three the next five
one three five and we repeat this and so
on
and so forth so that's how we work with
this
that said yeah we could also pick
reshuffle
each iteration so after each Epoch we're
gonna
reshuffle again so that's it uh we've
had our train data set shuffled and then
we have again trained data set
best so we we could just add this right
here actually we could say We'll
shuffled then we batch this by size 32
and then from here we could do
prefetching so let's do some prefetching
prefetch checking the documentation to
see what it takes this argument to see
again here we have a buffer size now
we are told that this allows later
elements to be prepared while the
current element has been pre-processed
or been processed and so if we have a
data set like this so let's suppose that
we have these three elements element one
element two and element three
So currently we are actually training on
this data on this batch here we're
actually training on this and generally
when we train on this like we have to
train after training we have to load
this data process it in case we need to
process it and then uh so let's let's
suppose that this is processing time
so uh for our key this is training time
after we process then after we train
after we process this
um here so after we process that and
then we train initially we even process
this so initially we will have this so
we process this one
we train we process we train we process
we train now what if instead of going
through this steps we we load so you
always start by loading we load and then
while we're training we actually loading
up our data so we could be loading up
our data while we're training so this
could be done and then after training we
have this loaded up data already so we
just continue with the training and then
from here
uh again while we're training here we
loading up so we're loading up
suppose we load things up like this and
then from here
uh from this point we train so recall we
have one two three train steps or Trend
blocks so at this point we add our last
block so that's it so from here we see
that we take less time
to load and train our data as compared
to this first method so working with
perfection is very important now this
profession takes up a buffer size which
can be auto-tuned so here you have
tf.dated.autotune in case you don't want
to specify the buffer size you could
just simply allow tensorflow dynamically
tune this buffer size for you
now that's set yeah we have this so we
have prefetch and then tf.didder dot
auto tune that's fine so that's our
dinner
um let's take this off so we now have
Trend theater our train data set let's
add this and let's run this actually and
then for
uh TN train getter
set we print out
C now with
um okay we've bashed that so let's print
out T and then let's play just the first
element actually uh let's see for X Y so
we could print out X and Y separately so
we have X Y you know there's a first
um that's it you see we're gonna have
this like this let's go up okay so yeah
we see we have
this right here uh what's its shape so
we have 32 by 8 which is normal by size
by eight and then uh we scroll down
scroll down yeah we have 32 by one which
is normal so that's very normal we've
passed our data and we're ready to train
this data so let's just recopy this and
do same for the validation right here we
have a validation
um valve data set and we have our data
set don't forget to change this so you
have vowel
that's it
that's fine uh we run this our valve
data set and now we go to the test
so right here you could also do same for
the test
um we have that
test
there we go test
test so that's what we need to do to
convert this so that we could use it as
um they all could work with a tensorflow
dealer API we don't do any modifications
on the model all we need to do here is
come and specify
train data set and then for validation
we have our Val data sets so here we
have our data set so that's fine
we see training has started and
everything seems okay so
um
will now go ahead and view this right
here
so that's what we get see so it still
continues dropping actually we could uh
from the previous
train we would have continued training
so we could have increased the number of
ebooks uh that's fine
let's look at this as well
and we could evaluate our model
now note that
um the this actually isn't very
different from what we had previously as
you may feel like this is producing a
different kind of
plot but
um the model is in its current state
already had a lust or was around I had a
lot of about 30 000 so if we have to
recompile our model so right here if we
have to run this
uh recompile our model and fit you get
to see that it isn't much different from
what we had previously so this doesn't
actually come to better our model our
model performance actually it comes to
speed up the training so you wouldn't
expect to have better lost values uh
with a TF the data
but instead you could attain this better
performance faster so let's run this
again and you get to see that it's kind
of like similar to what we had already
so that's fine uh we run this as well we
could always increase the number of
epochs you'll see that here
that's what I get and let's see we could
predict with this
fine and now we could go ahead
and do this on our bar chart so we look
at this similar to what we had already
so that's fine
we now master the basics of working with
editor API
though in subsequent sections we'll look
at even more interesting ways of working
with this API that's it hope you enjoyed
this thank you for following up to this
point don't forget to like subscribe and
share see you next time
hello everyone and welcome to this
session according to the world Hall
organization the estimated number of
malaria debts stood at 409 000 in the
year 2019. in this section we are going
to build a machine learning model based
on convolutional neural networks to
diagnose malaria in a person based on
Cell information gone from a microscope
in this section will start with loading
this data after loading out there we are
going to visualize this data process
this data build a model so that for this
data then screen this model and finally
evaluate and test our model as usual
we'll start by defining the task which
in this case entails correctly
classifying whether an input cell
contains the malaria parasite or not
then we'll go ahead to prepare our data
this data is going to be made available
to us from the tensorflow data sets then
we build a model the model or the
particular model we'll be working with
in this section will be the
convolutional neural network
then from here we'll Define the error
function would go ahead and train our
convolutional neural network we'll check
out on some performance measurement
metrics like accuracy F1 score Precision
recall and many others then we'll do
validation and testing and finally we'll
take as many creative measures as we can
in essence what we want to do is to
build a model like this which takes as
input this segmented cell from a team
blood smear and see whether this
segmented cell right here is parasitized
or unpartheidized we supposing you have
no medical background so we'll briefly
look at how malaria diagnosis is related
to those segmented blood cells to start
we get infected by malaria once we are
beaten by a mosquito this mosquito bite
usually lead to the passening of
plasmodium fasciferum parasite into our
blood system and so to diagnose whether
a particular person has got the malaria
or not it's important to get that
person's blood here you see how the
medical practitioner has to select the
finger to puncture usually the third or
fourth finger then to obtain this Blood
you puncture the side of the ball of the
finger and in the case the blood doesn't
well up you'll have to generally squeeze
the finger so you can obtain the blood
then always grabs the slight by its Edge
so to control the size of the blood drop
on the slide touch the finger to the
slide from below from that cdc.gov
website will get to this microbe notes
website where we'll get more colored
images now we've obtained the patient's
blood or the person's blood and there
are two possibilities one is getting a
thin smear like this and one is getting
a thick Smur in our case our data set is
gotten from a teen Smur like this so
here we have this thin Smur
which when passed on a microscope
produces images like this so here we
have teen blood film and we have thick
blood film from this point we now
segment this cells the cells are now
segmented and that's how we obtain an
image like this or a segmented
cell image like this which now could be
used by a model
to predict whether that patient has got
the malaria parasite or not it should
also be noted that we're dealing with a
classification problem since our output
can only take two discrete values this
type of classification problem is known
as binary classification since
throughout the section will be dealing
with image data it's important we
understand how image data is represented
so here we have this image of this bird
and then
when you zoom in this what you get if
you zoom in again you should have this
so this tells us that this image right
here is formed by
combining all these little boxes we have
right here and this box is known as
pixels
that said here we could localize this
pixel we have the speaks out this one
this one and so on and so forth so
basically this image is made of all this
little boxes which we call pixels
if now we take this image from our data
set you could see that we notice from
here we have 86 by 82 PX it is 6 by 82
pixel image meaning that we have 86
notice how here we go up to 86 so at
this point we have 86
and the width so we have it is six of
these boxes like if you have to go from
this point to this other point right
here we would go through 86 of these
pixels and then if you have to go from
this point to this one right here you
have 82
now check out what uh is displayed at
this position so as we move you should
be able to see what's displayed you see
that at this point for example we add
position 85
um 34 so we've gone 85 steps this
horizontally and then 34 steps
vertically we consider in our origin to
be at this top left corner right here so
we have 85 steps and then 34 steps in
this direction
and then you should be able to localize
this pixels right here so you could
notice how all those pixels now when
combined will be able to form this image
if you reduce this you see that it
becomes less evident to notice those
pixels so that's it
it should also be noted that each of
those pixels contain values ranging from
0 to
so here we have values ranging between 0
and 255.
and for each and every pixel we have
three different components the red the
green and the blue so if we break this
image here into this three different
components we would have something like
this now note that these values are
actually normalized so uh basically what
they've done here is you have taken all
these values and then they've divided by
255.
so if you want to get the unnormalized
values you should be able to take this
and multiply by 255 to obtain the
original values that said notice how at
this point here this position we have
this at this position we have this and
this
and so we could represent image data in
terms of the height
the width
and the number of channels which is in
this case equal three so we have height
that's the shape of our image tensor
hide my width by 3.
and another common format is the
grayscale format with a grayscale format
we this number of channels equal one we
have just one channel and it could be
represented as a 2d tensor
another interesting point to notice
though we're set for each position or
for each pixel we have a given value for
each component
we have
to note that all these values fall
between black
and white
that is for black if you want to get a
black value that the pixel value will be
zero and then for white the pixel value
will be
255. obviously when we normalize this
values
um yeah we're going from zero up to one
so that's it
in this data section we'll make use of a
data set contained in the tensorflow
data sets module right here so here you
just have to pick your problem and you
have a whole lot of data sets available
to you
when our case we're dealing with image
classification so we select this we
scroll down and we should get malaria so
here we have malaria so double click on
that and here we go we have our malaria
data set now you could visualize your
data set and you could get some
information or description about this
set the malaria data set contains a
total of 27 558 cell images with equal
instances of parasitized and uninfected
cells from the Teen blood smear slide
images of segmented cells so here we are
going to explore later
you could come right here draw the
border so that's why you have this
butter and then Group by level notice
how we have the parasitized level and
the uninfected level and both have equal
number of images so in fact what uh the
scientists have done together this data
set is they have gotten this
segmented blood cells from tested
malaria patients and this cells right
here from tested known malaria patients
let's click on this you see we have our
cells there we go
you could always visualize all the cells
here
and then let's get more information
about the image content metadata aspect
ratios you see there we go we have the
format this is PNG
megapixel resolution
uh mode RGB mode we're going to look at
this shortly uh pixel height 112 pixel
weight 91.
also note how not all the cells have
exactly the same pixel height and pixel
weight so they all have different pixel
Heights and pixel weights we have other
information about a data set like the
home page source code versions download
size data set size autocashed uh splits
in this case we just have a train split
so it's left on us to do this heading to
train validation and testing sets
we have the features here we see we have
an input image and we have the output
level note how number of classes here
are equal to now we could look at some
examples and finally we have the authors
in order to load this data so we could
make use of it we're gonna make use of
tensorflow dataset.load method right
here you see that this method takes
several arguments and this here have
default values but we need to specify
the string so when you specify the name
which in this case is malaria
this also has some outputs so if you get
this or if you succeed a load the data
set then you should be able to get this
output notice now how this integrates
with the tensorflow data API which we
talked off in the previous section and
which is an efficient way of dealing
with tensorflow data sets so here all
you need to do is to load the data and
you should have your tensorflow data set
with the data set information
let's now dive into code we'll start by
importing tensorflow numpy Maple leap
and we shall import tensorflow data sets
as tfds so we import our sensorflow data
sets that's fine and we could go
straight away into loading this data set
here we have tensorflow.load and we
specify the name malaria so once you
specify this you should obtain your data
set recall we have our data set
um let's say data set and we have data
set info
so that's it
let's run this
you see we downloading this data set
after loading the data set we obtain an
error so let's go ahead and check in the
documentation
by default this with info information
around here is false so
trying to get this data set information
right here which one error let's now add
this
with info right here with info would say
that to true and we run again
so you see that now all is well we have
our data set we have our data set
information which we could check out
right here so we have data set and then
we have data set info
that's it
um clearly we see uh
prefetched data set we have the image
and we have the level we have four
bitter data set we're gonna
print out uh data
and then after this we just take a break
we could also do for theater in data set
or take so just to take one element of
our data set instead of doing this let's
take this off so let's run that now
we have an error with the object has no
attribute take and that's because let's
run let's run the data set again
we run that and you see we actually have
this dictionary made of the train which
is our data send and we have the types
so let's specify we want to get uh just
the train right here uh we have data set
train and we run that again so now we
have our data you see we have this 103
around the three by three that's our
image and then if we scroll down you see
we have the level so we see it's one
let's scroll back and let's say we take
two values so let's let's take even four
values and see so we have those four
values you see let's scroll down we see
here we have one scrolling we have this
other one zero
different levels different images
and yeah we have one and here we have
one so that's it we see how we obtain
the images and the corresponding levels
we now pass in more arguments like the
shuffle files
as supervised and the split here we have
more elaborate explanation of how we can
work with a split you see we want to
split our data settings to say train and
test you could do this it does you could
simply pass this and or you could
specify the percentage of the training
set on the whole data set and go to the
specified the percentage of the trend of
the test set
so there we go we simply add as
supervised there we go through Shuffle
files
that we go through
and then finally we specify the split so
we have our split that's it we are going
to place this out we have the train test
so we could just simply do train test
let's take this off so or for now we
have the split train test and
um let's run this
we obtained this error telling us that
there's an unknown split test and that
the splits we have here should be part
of this list stream now actually in
other data sets available in tensorflow
data sets we already have the train test
split and in those cases we could make
use of this kind of split now we only
have the train so here is needless even
put in the split or you could just let's
just take this off let's take this off
now
and you'll see this should work fine so
that's it so we have a training set
we'll split this separately
and since we'll Shuffle the files now if
we run this or notice how the ship is
going to change because our files are
now shuffled so let's go up
um scroll this up there we go
and you see we have different files
whereas when we're done Shuffle or
when we set the shuffling to false you
will always have the same image at the
same position so that's it
um info specified and that's fine
in order for us to create this here
that's to create the
train validation and test sets we are
going to make use of the take method and
the skip method so let's take this
example we have this little this here we
created and we want to print out the
data set after skipping seven values so
here you see
if we skip seven values we have this now
if we take six values you see we have
those first uh
rather your take so let's put your take
we have
those first values
so let's do this at every level we print
out data set dot as
numpy iterator so we print out the data
set we have data set take we take the
first values let's define this
percentage
or the ratio we have the train ratio
this equals c 0.8 Val ratio equals 0.2
no 0.1 and the test ratio
equals 0.1 there we go we have the train
ratio validation ratio and that's ratio
now we are going to pick this up so we
have the length of our data set we could
let's let's come in this part and then
print out this length there we go we
have Lane of
data is set and as you could see we have
10 elements so when we run this you have
this elements here and Ln equal 10. now
that's set to obtain the trend data set
all we need to do is simply take the
first
eighty percent of our data set so yeah
we're gonna have this let's say train
data set and then we take 0.8 times the
length of uh let's let's define this
let's say we have Lan data all data set
size data set size there we go so we
have defined our data set size we have
that it is set size
that's fine
now that we have this we print out this
train data set so you could see here how
we're not able to convert this so let's
uh cannot convert 8 to eager chance of
type in 64.
right here we're supposed to pass in an
INT so let's have that
there we go
okay so we see that we have the first
eight elements right here we have this
this this eight now we're we have gotten
this eighty percent let's take this
let's see we take this to 60.
so let's reduce that and you have this
um sixty percent right here
um let's modify this
here so let's now have the train ratio
so here we have Trend ratio we run that
and there we go you see we have the top
sixty percent and if we get back to 80
we have the top eighty percent of the
all right of the first eighty percent
now we have the first sixty percent so
we have this first six elements right
here and we're left with this other four
elements now let's go ahead and see how
we could get this other four elements to
obtain this all we need to do is to
users keep so we're gonna have that and
Define our validation so we have your
vowel
now instead of taking the first six
elements we're gonna skip this first six
elements so we could start getting these
other elements right here so here we
have skip
and then we specify that we're skipping
those first six elements so here we're
gonna have six
so that's it and uh we print this out
let's have this file right here so
that's it we have our validation so we
get this first six elements but recall
that our validation is in fact this two
elements right here so what we're gonna
do again is after skipping and getting
this last element which essentially is
made of the validation and training set
we are now going to take out uh take the
first two elements which correspond to
the validation set so right here we have
vowel data set is now equal notice how
instead of data set as previously now
we're dealing with the valid data set so
we have validity set dot take so here we
have a valid setup take what are we
taking we're taking this first two
elements which could be obtained by
having this int of vowel so where we
have vowel ratio
times
our data set size so times our data set
size we have the valve data set and now
let's run this
there we go you see we have now six
seven now in order for us to get this
next all what we need to do is to skip
so uh we've gotten this as validation
data set let's call this valve test
actually
let's see this is our valve test and
yeah we have our overall test so we we
get the valve test which is this to
obtain the validation we take this first
two and then to obtain the test we skip
this first two so right here we are
gonna copy this again and then paste
this out we have the test
which sticks to the valve test and then
takes as well test but the difference is
here we have this keep so we run this
and there we go
it's not exactly what we expect we
should change this yeah we have test so
that's it now we've gotten all the we've
gotten the train set we've got the
validation set and we've got in the test
set
we could play around with this values
let's suppose we have no validation so
we have that you see that we have this
empty list and then all this is used for
the test
now we could create a function from
we'll call this function the splits
function so we have our splits function
what it takes in is the ratio so we have
the train
the train ratio the validation ratio we
have the test ratio that's it and what
does it do it simply does exactly what
we've just done right here so let's copy
this out let's cut down and then have
the year here are we taking the data set
too so we have our data set and that's
it no need to Define our data set again
so we just have this data set and let's
take this off
so we cut that off let's put this here
and we have our data set size from the
data set we Define a trend data set no
no pins in again we have the validation
we have that take this off we have the
test and then we go ahead and return so
we return our train data set our
validation data set and our test data
set so that's it so we'll return all
this and let's
let's send this up so we've had we have
this metal right here which we've built
and then from this we have our data set
we're going to pass this in here so
let's have
um let's say we want to have valve so we
have Val data around the train train
data set we have our data set we have
test data set and this equals split of
data set and the train
train ratio
Val ratio and test ratio so that's it so
we've passed all this in and then now we
could uh from here
clean out
so yeah we could print out our train
data set for example so we have this
string to the set we will print out our
valve data set and then we could bring
out our test data set
so we get this right that's it we run it
and
with those pit is not defined this
actually splits so let's have that s
run again and that's fine there we go we
have our 3D sets so we have our train we
have a validation and then we have our
test data set in here we could always
have this so we could see a list
as
numpy iterator so here we have this
um there's a list so we have that and
that's it so there we go we have the
train we could do same for the
validation and the testing this is what
we now obtain we can now test out the
splitting with our own data set so we'll
comment this part and go with a data set
we will load this
here we go we've reloaded that and then
we shall pass this data set now in your
so we should have this
um let's rerun this run this and that's
fine so now we have this error this
object has no attribute tick to better
understand this error
let's run this cell right here you see
this data set is actually made up of a
list this list uh is made of the data
set and the types so when we doing this
we actually taking the latest like we're
taking all this list dot thick
so what we will do we should pick out
just the data set and to do that all we
need to do is specify here that we are
picking out just the data set so that's
that we we've picked out a data set we
could now run this before running this
let's make sure we take out just an
element because running that four data
set is going to be very time consuming
so let's take this one and take this out
right here so that's fine now we will
run this and with a little now as you
could see you have this right here
that's the image and
the level given to us uh notice how we
have this empty list because we've said
here that we want our validation ratio
to be equal to zero so since we have
this at zero we have the empty list for
the validation so our validation is
actually empty now
you could modify this let's take 0.1 0.1
and right here 0.8 we will run that
and here's a response we get so that's
fine uh we have all the we have the
validation training test set which uh
non empty lists
we'll now get into visualizing our data
set uh visualizing some elements
nowadays set so we have for I
um image so here we're picking out the
image and the level in enemy rates
and we have the train data set you could
as well pick out the validation of the
test and data set so we have that let's
take say 16 elements and then uh for all
this we'll uh come up with subplots
and here we pick out four by four
because we are having to
block out 16 different images
at this point
we do plot dot in show of our image so
that's our image we're planning out and
then uh we'll run this
here's what we get this actually what we
expect and now what we could do is uh by
the side of every image we could put out
a level for each and every image we'll
put out a title we have the title and
what we'll do is we have this is set
info because here we're interested in
getting the corresponding level name so
we have
um say a level zero wanna get his name
and we have we could have a level one we
want to get this particular name
here we have this and we have the
features
to understand this better you could
check out this data set info right here
you notice that we have this features
and then we'll pick out the level
that said we are just gonna go straight
away into this we have level and then we
convert this into a string so we have
the string and then we pass in the level
now we're passing on this level we've
got right here for the corresponding
image and then once we have this right
we run it
and we take this off
so that should be fine now we have this
images and the corresponding levels you
can see how though this is parasitized
this for example is uninfected but this
isn't very clear so let's take off this
throughout that axis
we'll set this to off
run that
and that looks better but we could make
this bearing if you want to know which
of these is the level zero and which is
the level one let's take this from here
and then we print out say zero you see
that this level is zero it's given to us
as parasitized and one is uninfected so
that's it
at this point we're gonna dive into data
processing our data processing unit for
now will be made of two parts the first
part will be the resizing part so if we
have an input image of say 102 by 102
as width and height we're going to have
this we're gonna transform this into an
image of a fixed width and fixed height
now that said all our images
irrespective of their widths and Heights
will now have just one width and one
height in this case we'll consider an
image a size of 224 so our weight on the
high will be converted to 224 and
subsequently we'll see why we are
picking this
image size right here
after this resizing our next part will
be on normalization so we'll have an
input image which will normalize such
that all the ditter falls in a given
range
here we have the standardization process
and we have the normalization process in
this case we are going to use a
normalization process and we're going to
explain why in the previous example on
the car price prediction
we actually work with standardization
and standardization each value is
subtracted from the mean and then
divided by the standard deviation that's
actually H value
on each and every column of X right here
is being standardized based on its mean
and the standard deviation as you'll
notice
these values for example are normally
distributed that is we have a mean value
on average value and we have a standard
deviation or range of values where most
of times our values will fall in so it's
going to look bell shaped like this as
we've seen before we have the mean and
then we have a certain standard
deviation right here
and that's why if you look at X2 you
wouldn't have say 5 600 7100 and then
yeah for example come and have a value
like say 12. this isn't very typical
since uh most of the times it's values
for under a given range and there's a
certain
average value for which most other
values just fall around so that's why
it's
um typical to have those kinds of values
let's take this off
um for the next you'll notice how these
values fall under a given kind of range
and with this too
now this is for when we're done with
standardization and that's why
previously we used this actually now in
the case of image data the choice of
whether to standardize or to normalize
will depend on the kind of data we're
dealing with so if we have images where
most of its pixels revolve around a
particular mean value then we want to
standardize and if this image is made of
pixels where their values are mostly
different from one another then we would
want to normalize now in our case or as
we uh continue in the section we are
going to go with normalization that is
we'll have x minus x mean which is 0
divided by x max which is 255.
minus x mean which is zero so simply do
x divided by 255 so we'll normalize the
inputs before passing them into our
model now it should be noted that for
some other data sets like for example
imagenet or imagenet we have imagina
data set or the r d e
20K
um image segmentation data set they have
they are known
um mean and standard deviation values
nonetheless for whatever problem you
have to deal with you may work with
standardization or normalization
experiment for yourself and see which
one works better
now that said since we're dealing with
the tensorflow data API we are going to
use this map method to help us in this
pre-processing so there we go we have
trained data set we'll start first with
the resizing trend is set equal training
data set dot map and then we'll call
this resizing method which we shall
Define let's add this and put this up
here so we have our resizing method this
method takes in the image and the level
so we have our image and the level right
here but note that we're doing
processing on only the image so we're
going to pass this in and then we're
going to resize this using the resize
method which comes with tensorflow
images right here so we have tensorflow
image and then we have the precise
method here you could see the arguments
which are passed for now we'll focus on
the image and the sides we will also
note that you to change the method using
resizing but for now we use this
default values given to us
so that's it we are going to return uh
the image so let's uh have our
tensorflow image dot resize and it takes
an image and then we have
the image size so we'll have M size by m
size note that uh we are going to define
the instance here so we have imp size
equal to 124. so we have this resizing
all images will turn into this 224 by 24
um shaped image now we have resized this
we just put out a level so here again we
just basically taking the image
resizing it and then the level Remains
the Same so we could run this and then
we have our train data set which now has
been resized
that's it we could see four
editor in train data set we're gonna
print out oh let's take one value so
yeah we take just one value and we have
our let's say image actually image and
level
we print out we print out the image and
the level this on that and there we go
you'll notice that the shape of this
image is going to be 224 by 224
irrespective of whichever or which image
you pick and then we have its level
which is which remains unchanged notice
how this is a floated tool unlike
previously where we had
and unsigned end now you could always do
casting right here to modify this
depending on
what you're working on so that's it
we're done with the resizing we could
now look at
rescaling so let's let's put this as
precise in and rescaling so we have
resizing resize let's just say resize
rescue so our recycling skill function
is such that after resizing we will
scale by dividing by
255 so we divide all our values by 255
um our label Remains the Same we run
this uh we run that here is the size we
scale there we go we run that and then
we have this so that's fine just as we
did before that's in the previous
section we're gonna Shuffle our data
we're gonna put this in batches and then
we'll you do Perfection so all this was
explained in the previous section
we are now ready to build our model and
up to now neural networks have been
performing quite well we had seen
previously that if we have three neurons
that's one two three in the input
and in the output we have three neurons
two then there will be nine different
connections here and hence nine
different weights plus the bias
but for this example let's consider only
the weights so we have nine different
parameters for three inputs three
outputs
and if here we have five Constitution
only the weights we would have three
times five that's fifteen different
parameters
now if we're dealing with an image like
this one so let's consider this image
which is uh 224
by 224 by 3 image three for the three
different red green and blue channels so
we have this input image now so unlike
previous examples where we would have
features
or specifically in this case input
features which not contain as many
elements as this we now have this case
where if we want to count the number of
features or the number of pixels would
have
528 different input features to take
into consideration hence instead of
having a total number of three right
here we're gonna have a hundred and
fifty thousand five hundred and twenty
eight different values and if we want to
do the same competition which got us
this number of parameters would have 150
000 times 3 that's approximately five
four hundred and fifty thousand
different parameters
now what if we modify this number of
neurons right here and take say a
thousand neurons in this output right
here we would see that we'll move from
150 000 or rather from 450 000 to 150
million different parameters
where each and every parameter has to be
trained and optimized
this becomes clear that deep neural
networks like this are better still
dense layers are fully connected layers
aren't scalable
since when we increase the number of
features the total number of parameters
also increase considerably hence we need
to build a type of layer unlike this one
where each neuron isn't connected to all
the previous neurons and this layer
happens to be the convolutional layer in
order to better visualize this we'll use
this thermal platform from rice and
University so here we'll put in a figure
let's say four
and then we'll see exactly how Those
comp Nets work so we have this and then
we have this input right here to get
this input we have
some weights and then this output
features note how to obtain this
particular pixel right here only a few
of these inputs are used and so yeah we
call this the receptive field as you
could see we have the receptive field
right here
and if we take this other example you
see it's unreceptive field you see if to
get this value only these four values
you see below
um actually this one this this and this
as you could see here scroll back okay
so only those four values have a role to
play when it comes to giving us the
corresponding value we have here
and so unlike with a dense layer where
to obtain this value we needed to link
this to each and every previous neuron
now only just some neurons in this
neurons receptive field play a role in
getting this value another great tool
for better understanding the
convolutional layer is this CNN
explainer actually CNN stands for
convolutional neural networks this is
created by J Wong Robert Omar park
that's Frank Kang and Below we are
really grateful for this tool before
getting back to the explainer let's take
this example right here we have a 4x4
image so we have 16 different pixels if
we flatten out this pixels that's if we
put this pixels out like this
such that we have those inputs and then
in the output we have four different
neurons then here would have 16 by four
connections that will have 64 different
parameters excluding the bias but with a
count layer we could leave from this 4x4
to just a two by two so we could leave
from this four by four to this two by
two
with just nine parameters so we would
have what we call a kernel right here or
filter so we have this filter which is
three by three
which actually corresponds to our
weights which we've seen already this
kernel here kernel size three
will produce this output
of two by two which when we flatten out
can give us this output right here and
so instead of working with 64 parameters
we're working with nine parameters if we
want to replicate that same example in
the CNN explainer here's what we get we
have this input right here which
produces this output now notice how we
specify that the canal size equal three
and because the candle size equal to V
we are able to get this output but how
is this output gotten you would see that
at this top left corner we are going to
fit our kennel which is of size three by
three so we put in our kennel right here
and then we take each and every value of
our kennel and multiply it with the
corresponding value in the input to
obtain the first value you see how we
pass this kernel on the input so at this
top left position with passive kernel
notice how all we have a three by three
candle which is passed on this input and
we have the output right here then to
get the next position to get this next
output you see how this kernel is passed
on this next part of the input and the
way we get this next part is by simply
sliding to the through the image you see
how we learn from this we slide that
through the image and we got this we got
this next output and since we've gotten
to the end we've moved to the next
position which is this we get this next
we get this next value right here and
then from here we slide again to this
end and we finally get this value so
that's how we get all this outputs from
the inputs and the kernel or the filter
we can now go ahead and increase this
input size let's take for example seven
you see we have a input size of seven
seven by seven input image
and then we have this output five by
five the reason why we have this five by
five is because we have this kernel size
of three if we get to increase the
counter size of five you see our output
reduces you see when the kernel size
gets to six our output reduces let's
take this back to three so you take back
to three and this input of seven by
seven gives us an output of five by five
we see how when we get to this we have
that output move slide slide slide slide
move to this next here slide slide slide
and so on and so forth right up to the
end so from here we'll see how the size
of the receptive field of each of those
outputs equal to V which is actually our
Canal size
the next thing to notice is
reducing the kernel size will miss us
extract more features from the inputs
you'll see that since we have this input
7x7 we kind of size of three we have the
output five by five so we've extracted
much more features from this input as
compared to when we push the kernel size
of six here will extract less features
from this inputs now though using a
smaller kind of size parameters extract
much more complex information or complex
features from the inputs working with
larger kernels parameters extract larger
input features one logical question
which may come to you minus how do I get
the size of this output feature map
right here
to get this we'll use this formula where
this output width is equals the input
width minus the field to size plus one
if you take this example we have an
input weight of 7
minus the filter size of 3 plus 1 this
gives us five so that's how we obtain
this right here
now if we take
um say
kind of size let's take the camera size
to be four for example
in that case we have 7 minus
the candle size 4 which is three plus
one which gives us an output of four and
that's how we obtain this outputs right
here
now in a case where you're designing a
convolutional layer and you want to get
a particular feature Map size say for
example in this case if you want to get
an output size of three
then all you need to do is specify this
kennel size to be equal five and you
should get this output
now in some cases you may want to have a
particular feature map shape but using
just the kernel size you wouldn't be
able to get that and so to match up with
the particular output shape would
include a pattern let's look at this
pattern you see we're having seven by
seven and when we take this to one you
see that we go from seven by seven to
now nine by nine notice how it's written
here after pattern we have nine by nine
so we live from this seven by seven
let's take this in this box right here
this internal box and then the pattern
is also nine by nine notice how after
doing the pattern and if we play around
with our Channel size we go from one one
to eight eight so we go from one one to
eight eight but with zero padding
and the input size of seven
you see we go two three four and six so
we cannot go up to eight eight we're
gonna have an output of eight eight when
the pattern is zero whereas when we
increase the padding by one
year increase the pattern by one that's
one you see that we could go from we
could get an output
of say let's put 10 out of three we
of seven
of eight you see up to one so that's it
now or we understand how this pattern
Works basically we just have our input
and then we add this surrounding
elements right here I'll just pad our
input image now the pattern generally we
use is the zero pattern though the other
pattern methods but the zero pattern is
one of the most common since it's easy
to use and it's computationally less
expensive to work with so that said
there's our padding and then we also
have another advantage of working with
the pattern which is that of ensuring
that the corner
pixels have an influence on our output
features which are generated now let's
take this back to zero pattern we have
zero pattern and we have this input
image right here
if we're doing an image in which most of
the information and most of the relevant
information is centered then there is
actually no issue since this filter
right here will go through each and
every pixel we have where we have this
person and the image now if we modify
this image such that we have a person's
let's suppose we have a person's face
here just at the corner of the image
you'll see that unlike with this image
where this person was centered and that
our kennel
was able our filter was able to pass to
each and every part of this image with
this one we have a different scenario
we've just modified this so it looks
similar to what we had here now
um what we could do is
if we monitor the number of times this
filter goes through the person's head
would see that would have year one time
because our filter passes here once the
next time after the sliding will have
this so second time the next time after
this Auto sliding will lead to this four
times
so unless it passes through the head and
then here we have
um five times now we have one two three
four times actually but in this case
since we are around the borders you see
we have this one time
and that's particularly all so we see
that in this example or in this case
where we are on the butters this
influences the outputs
in a smaller way or
exerts less influence on the values we
get in this feature Maps which are
generated
so in an example where this let's
suppose an example where all this wasn't
there and that where our information
lies most is this you'll find that it
would have been better
to at least pass through this head
region just as we did with this year
where we pass through the head region
four times and we're built to extract
very useful information from this image
because our filter goes through this
many more times
now to remember this the situation we
have the pattern you see that when we
increase the padding so let's take this
to one we've increased the pattern let's
increase the pattern to
oh okay yeah let's fix to just one
anyway we just increase the pattern to
one and then we'll retake that example
now I'll take an example we'll see that
if we maintain our filter size of two
this filter here will at least touch the
head although slightly and then the
second one does this twice
so in this case our filter touches the
head twice as compared to previously
where it touches the head only once and
hence this useful information has more
influence on the output features which
is being generated right here and which
is very important as practically that's
what we're trying to do we're trying to
extract information from this input and
pass to the output
another hyper parameter which we could
look at is a stride now note that for
now we've looked at this one this and
this so here's what we call the hyper
parameters
we have the stride and we'll understand
surely how this works for now we'll deal
with the strand of one y one simply
because you just slide in through one
step for going to the next so you do
slide one one one and so on and so forth
now if you move this to two we start
from this position right here let me fix
that you start from this position
um there's a problem
we get back to one
and but two you notice that as we go to
one distance blue and then to two it
turns red and the reason why it turns
red is because there is no valid output
or there's no whole number which uh with
a slider stride of two can produce an
output so in fact what we're going to do
is we modify this input right here so
modifying this input this works now so
it's possible for us to live from this
input of 6 to this output but with a
side of two so let's Now understand how
strides work we start with this notice
now how we're going to skip two steps
instead of just one step so as we go you
see we skip two steps now this two
two and that's it so we move to the next
and now even moving downward you see
it's not like with a strike one where we
just had one step like we'll just try
one we just did this one step but we'll
just try two we're going two steps below
so that's it now that said
increase in the size of our stride
actually reduces the size of our output
and hence reduces the amount of
information we extract from the inputs
and so in general we get better results
by working with smaller kernels and
smaller strained values since we're able
to extract more information from our
inputs
generally the candle size is used to
read the kind of side of three is
generally used in practice and a strand
of one so we may decide to use padding
or not
and the new formula when we include the
padding and the stride is given as such
so we have the output we call the input
size minus the filter size plus two
times the pattern divided by the stride
plus one in this case if we have an
input size of six so here we have six we
have six minus filter size three
plus two times the pattern also a
pattern one so it's plus two
divided by The Stride let's try this one
and plus one there we go we have an
answer of three plus two
which is five and then plus one which is
six so that's how we obtain this output
um size right
also note that one good thing when
working with a library like tensorflow
is when you don't know the exact pattern
to use such that you have particular
output size you could specify the
pattern to be valid once you specify the
pattern to be valid tensorflow
automatically calculates the pattern for
you such that the output you want
matches up up to this point we've been
supposing that our input image is
two-dimensional that is we have a height
and a width now what if we use the kinds
of images we have in real life that is
3D images where we have the red channel
the green Channel and the blue channel
so if we have this RGB image right here
RGB image uh we'll see how we get the
output now the way this is done is quite
straightforward so what we have is in
this case we include this pattern so
it's using zero padded we've included
this pattern and then we have our kennel
right here now notice how we have this
kernel and then it goes through this
first part of this top left corner and
what we do is we multiply each value
right here we have negative one times
zero plus negative one times zero plus
negative 1 times 0 and so on and so
forth up to plus negative 1 times 0
right here you have negative one times
four so basically what we're doing here
is kind of like a DOT product so we're
taking all these elements multiplying by
the corresponding elements and then
adding all this up once all this added
up we should have 41 so you could take
this as a simple exercise and then you
should be able to get 41 and then we
have this other candle right here where
we repeat the same process we have this
and then we have this kernel we have
this so here what we do is we have uh we
take this we obtain this value take this
obtain this value this obtain is value
and then we add all this up to get this
answer 41. now note that we also have
the bias which we've now included so for
now we have this 41. now we move to the
next step so we slide through next step
yeah the stride is equal one actually
from here we do the same process
negative one times zero this negative
one times the zero add it up and all of
that so all that added up all this added
up all this added up we have 12. we
repeat the same process right up to the
end so that's how we obtain our output
right here you could also check out on
this other more visually appealing
example in the CNN Explorer website so
here we double click on this and then we
see exactly what's going on
we have the year you see how we form in
this outputs by sliding through the
kennels over the inputs
so here I click on this you see I slide
through this and you see how all these
values are multiplied and then added
together to form the output so that's it
from this point we move to this
explained visually project by cetusa
filtering the course part of image
processing and since we're dealing with
image data year it's important for us to
better understand how this works so
right here we'll choose a kernel or a
filter or let's pick this sharpen filter
right here of this sharpen kennel notice
how it wants to pick a kernel these
values change that's the values of the
filters actually change let's take this
outline you know there's a change now
let's uh keep this our line and then
we'll notice that every time we that is
hover over this input image we have the
values right here that's to the right so
for now we have this and then let's
notice that here we have this negative
one that's negative one times at this
position notice at this position we have
the value
255 so 255 there's negative 1 plus 255
that's negative one plus uh unknown
value on non year because we are the
borders so there is no value and then we
have 249 times negative one two fifty
five times eight two thirty three times
negative 1 255 times negative one and
then all this sums up to give us a given
value since we have these unknown values
here is unknown so we have no value
there but if we change this position and
then we fit around the I region you see
we have a value of negative 533 so uh we
notice that no matter the image we put
in your will always get an output where
the outlines
are being highlighted
so if you check out this image which
we've just imported of Elon Musk you see
that the output is this
image right here which highlights the
edges
and so as is explained here uh the
Highlight large differences in pixel
values which generally occur at the
edges so around those regions you see
there's large differences have been
outlined as compared to this Zone here
where there is no difference and since
there is no difference we just have this
uh black region
so here again you see that we have the
filter that's it this is the exact same
value we have right here we have the
filter and then this example shows us
how this output is gotten
now the major difference between what
we're doing right here and the
convolutional neural networks is that
with this we know this canal values so
we know that we have this Matrix
negative one negative one negative one
negative one eight negative one negative
one negative one negative one which is
an edge detector so we know this and
then we know the obvious output but with
the convolutional neural network or with
a convolution layer to be specific what
we do is initially we just initialize
these values and we let the model
doing training to learn these values
automatically so these values are
learned by the model during training
automatically
one of the very first convolutional
neural networks or confidence was built
by Young lacun in 1989.
and right here we have the structure of
this confident known as the Lunette
this Lynette takes in an image here we
have a 28 by 28 by one image here we
just have one channel black and white
image and then we pass this to a
convolutional layer which we've just
seen after passing through a
convolutional layer we have
um the sigmoid but also note that here
we have a 5x5 kernel we have a plus two
padding so if a zero pattern will add
zeros around our input and then add
another zero on another group of zeros
around our features then from here we
have this output 28 by 28 by 6. so
shortly we'll see exactly how this
output is gotten so we've seen we have
the sigmoid activation from here we have
the pulling layer now this is a sub
sampling layer and we'll understand how
it works so we have two by two average
pulling kennel
and we'll just try it of two
from this we have another convolutional
layer with five by five kernel here is
no padding and we have this output
activation pulling flattening we flatten
in all the features I've been modified
so we'll leave from this 3D tensor to a
1D tensor and then we have this dance
fully connected layer followed by
sigmoid followed by another dance fully
connected layer followed by sigmoid and
finally we have this dense layer with
output 10 neurons
and the exact reason why we have this
output of 10 classes or 10 neurons since
we have 10 classes is because we were
predicting whether an input is either a
one so this inputs are images of
handwritten digits so we want to predict
whether the handwritten digit is a one
or a two or three up to nine and so here
we have this and then we also have a
zero so that makes 10 so 0 to 9 gives us
10 possibilities and that's why we have
10 different classes right here now for
the Alex next
it was built to correctly classify
whether an input image belongs to one of
a thousand classes in the image net data
set so here we have this Alex net with a
different architecture as we could see
right here
and now we'll go ahead and understand
how all those outputs are gotten
and so we'll be rebuilding the Lynette
architecture but this time around
considering an input 64 by 64 by 3. so
right here we have the RGB channels
we have r
G
and B
if we pass this input now through this
convolutional layer we're gonna have
this output and how do we get this
output to get this output we have to
take into consideration this parameters
which have been given to us for the
convolutional layer that said the photo
size equal five so we have here through
the size of five there is no padding
stride equal one and then the number of
filters equals six
we'll calculate the number of parameters
shortly anyway these are the four most
important parameters
so here we have this and this is what we
call our filter we have this filter you
see that we have the dot products which
are completed together outputs as usual
and so we take this like this are like
our R we have this then we photos with
this and then we follow with this so we
take this and then computed the products
and with the other two and then from
this we add all this up to obtain each
and every value for this very first
feature map right here so to obtain this
feature map we are using this filter
now
this shows us clearly that when we
specified that the number of photos
equals six it doesn't mean we actually
have just six of this as you may feel
like
um
number of photos equals six means we
have six filters stacked like this here
we have five and then six so we feel
like we have just six stack like this
which is not actually the case what
happens is uh we have three there's this
three
channels and then each of our filters
also have the three channels as you
could see
and so
what we call a filter here is this three
all right as this five by five by three
kernel right here now we've done the
competition and we've had for this we
repeat the same
process so we take this for the r we
repeat this we repeat this and then we
open this next we do all this the same
way up to this position and then we have
this right here and that's why when we
have six filters we're always going to
have six channels
then if you do five by five by three and
all that times six so if you have five
by five times three that's 75 75
times six should give you
a total of 450 and since for each of
these filters we add the bias that is we
have an extra bias for each of those
filters we have one two three four five
six biases so adding this plus six we
have four hundred and fifty six
parameters to be trained so here we have
450 weights and six biases
that said we've understood why we have
the six channels now how do you obtain
the 60 by 60 the way we obtain the 60 by
60 is by applying this formula which
we've seen already so here we just have
uh the output equal
64. filter size five so we have minus
five
adding no pattern so pattern is zero
side one so we have 64 minus five and
then plus one this gives us 64 minus
four which is equals sixty and that's
how we have this output right here
from here we move to the sub sampling
pulling layer for the pulling layer we
have this two parameters that is we have
the number of filters and then all right
we have the filter size not the number
of filters the filter size and then we
have the number of strides
to obtain the dimension for the pulling
the formula is slightly different
obviously because here we don't have the
pattern so we have x minus F divided by
S Plus One and then we'll leave from
this to this feature map right here
notice how we still maintain the number
of channels but our
input feature map has been sub sampled
for the particular case of Max pooling
if you want to understand how this works
let's be let's say we have this position
let's take this position let's take a
position where we have some values
notice how as we pick this value you see
the max is 0.02 so if you look around
look at this so we see here the max is
0.08 and then and so on and so forth so
basically what we're doing is was just
simply sliding through the whole image
and then for every since our candle size
is equal to we have a two by two Canal
size here so for every four values
we are gonna pick out one to represent
them and in this case this one is the
max in some cases uh we'll instant take
the average of this that's known as
average pulling but for this Max pulling
which is
the most commonly used we take the max
of all these different values
that said to obtain this we have X that
is in this case we have x equals 60 so
let's take this off x equals 60
minus f
equal to
divided by The Stride I'll try this two
and then plus one so 60 minus 2 58
divided by 2
29 plus 1 gives us 30 that's how we get
this we're still maintain a number of
channels
here's another example showing even more
clearly how this Max pooling works or
pulling in general works so if we have
this input so we're picking out just one
of this suppose we're picking out just
one of these channels and we have this
we are going to have our kennel two by
two that's it and then what get what we
get is output is zero since the max of
zero zero zero is zero we do we have a
stride of two so notice how we've
shifted my two positions to try two and
then the max here is two we move again
strike two Max now is two we move you
see Max is one move back to zero and
then you go to the next Max three and so
on and so forth so that's how we obtain
this new
um feature map right here notice how we
have this is five uh ten
five ten and then here we have five five
so we'll leave from ten by ten to five
by five
after this sub-sampling layer we have
the activation we've already looked at
activation in the previous section we've
seen the sigmoids and we've seen the
value within the tank and we've seen the
Leaky relu so that said we understand
that and now we move to the next
convolutional layer of filter size equal
five adding no padding stride one number
of filters 16 number of parameters
2416. so you could take this as an
exercise to be able to show that the
total number of parameters we have is
2416. that said we're going to have this
output right here uh we have the relu
added and then we have this output so we
have the output 26 or 26 by 26 by 16.
recall number of filters dictates the
number of channels right here and not uh
the filter sizes the number of filters
and then this 26 by 26 is Garden by
using the same formula we've seen
already
from here we have another sub sampling
we've understood that already and then
we flatten all this out so after doing
the sub sampling we have this 13 by 30
by 16 when you multiply all this it
should give you 2704
and this is what we call the flattening
layer so we pass this to a flattened
layer to obtain this now this takes each
and every value we have here in our
feature map and then just simply places
it in this one dimensional output right
here then from here we have the dense
layer which we're used to working with
already and then we have a thousand
neurons the output and finally we have
200 neurons in our case we should have
two since we're actually predicting
whether it's a parasite or is
non-parasite so we should just have two
anyways we understand all this now
and we should be ready to dive into the
code before moving on to the code let's
get to see what the feature maps of a
trained convolutional neural network
looks like as you could see right here
from this example from the Stanford
website
we have this car which is passed into a
convolutional neural network and then
its output we have it predicting a car
as you can notice this first layers
actually
serve as filters for low level features
like the edges so you'll notice that
this
input or this feature maps from the
first layers produce visually
interpretable outputs
now you will notice also that as we go
further or deeper
we have this outputs which are less
visually interpretable and the focus
more on High level features like the car
parts with parameters correctly classify
that this image contains a car
and so the first layers are for feature
extraction and then the last layers are
for classification
both subsections actually need each
other as if you do feature extraction
and you don't have layers which are able
to parameters correctly classify this
image then will not
achieve our goal and in the same sense
if we have a good classifier but we get
this kind of inputs directly
well with not extracted useful features
from them yet then our classifier is not
going to perform well you could also
check this carbonate amnest demo by
Andres caparti where he trains a model
on the amnest data set here we have our
model the input conf pool conf pool and
soft Max so here we have this on endless
data set and then we're having this
passed in as you could see notice how in
this first layers the feature Maps
actually contain much more visual
content as compared to this final layers
right here see if you look at those
final layers you'll see that we have
this feature Maps which instead contain
content which permits us say whether a
particular input belongs to a particular
class
I want to build convolutional layers
with tensorflow you could make use of
those tensorflow Keras model right here
so that set we're just gonna come to the
layers so you have the carers and then
we pick layers and then we'll find the
comp 2D layer so here is a layer with
section four double click on that and
then yeah we go we have the arguments
that's what we pass in this layer
the filters right here corresponds to
the number of filters so let's take this
off here is a number of filters we've
seen this already and F and then the
kernel size corresponds to the filter
size
from there we move to the strides which
take a tuple let's take this off and
check this out so here we have this
Tuple actually and then what's important
to note here is the fact that if you
want to do striding of say one two that
is one two
then
in the height Dimension your strident is
going to be equal one and then the width
Dimensions trying to be equal to so if
we have this feature map right here and
we pass a kernel
we are going to be sliding
and skipping two steps on this
horizontal Direction while when we come
in when we're going downwards we are
going to be skipping only one step so
that's what this means now in the case
where we are having exactly the same
number of steps sliding horizontally and
vertically then the striding like in
this case can just be given as equal one
from there we have the pattern but
therefore the pattern is valid here we
told that
uh for the pattern
if the pattern is valid it means there's
actually no pattern so we have zero
pattern and then when the pattern is
same the result of the pattern or the we
added with zeros to ensure that the
input Dimension equals the output
dimension
also note that this is only possible
when the stride is equal one
so that said oh if we have a feature map
like this
let's say we have 60 by 60 and then we
want to pass this through account layer
to get an output feature map and if we
want this apple feature map to be the
same Dimension as the input that is 60
by 60 then all we need to do is specify
that the pattern is same so once we have
this the output will be the same as that
of the input
from here we have the data format now
note that there are generally two kinds
of data formats that is we have hive
so for an image we have the height width
and then the channel
so if we have a 224
by 224
by 3 image
then we actually making use of this
dative format now we could also use this
format where we start with the channel
so we have the channel by height and by
width
and so here we have 3 by 224 by 224 note
that by default we have the channel live
so by default we have this first
convention last right here but if you
want to take this convention all you
need to do is specify that you're
working with the channels first
then from here we have the dilation rate
so we'll look at this GitHub repository
by vdumulon
where he uses animations to explain how
convolutions work
you could scroll down and you'll find
the dilated convolution animation which
when we click on we have this so there
we go we have this example in which the
dilation rate is equal to
so the way this dilation works is we
have this kernel which initially
had no spaces between its values so we
had something like this we have this
three by three kernel and now what we do
is we have this pieces all this holds
between this different values and so now
what we get is
some sort of five by five kernel right
here if we're working with a dilation
rate R equals three then instead of a
single whole year we are gonna fit in to
all our holes so we're gonna have this
we just have one two and then we fit
this then we have one two and then we
fit this
so that's how we we build this out we
have this and then that now to get the
shape we have one two three four five
six seven so we have a seven by seven
filter now it should be noted that the
dilated convolutions are used in
problems where we want to keep
increasing the receptive field as we
keep going deeper in the network while
maintaining the number of parameters the
next argument is the groups and
according to the documentation this is a
positive integer specifying the number
of groups in which the input is split
along the channel axis this means that
in this case for example we could break
this up into three different groups so
we have one two and then two regroups
then each group has its own group
filters
and then the output is a concatenation
of all the group results across the
channel axis
from here we have the activation
which we've seen already and then we'll
see whether we're going to use the
buyers or not
we have this kernel that is the weight
initialization and then we have the bias
initialization we have this regular
Rises which we'll see subsequently
and then we have the kernel and buyers
constraints
in order to create our convolutional
neural network we're just going to make
use of this sequential API which we had
built previously and then we'll Define
the input layer so here we have this
input shape 224 let's we add Define this
as M size actually so we have aim size
that's it by m size by three we could
also Define a number of channels but
let's just let it to be equal to V then
from here we have no normalizer and then
we have this count 2D layer right here
so we have this arguments which are
default so we'll then bother to check on
this we will take this off take this off
and that's fine so we'll have this
there we go we have our conf2d
I'll come today which we copy all right
I will cut that off and then we put this
after the input layer right here so
there we go we have our input layer we
want six filters and then with a candle
size of five
so that's it I'll try it we could take
this to be equal one there we go add-in
is valid so that's what we expect and
then just here we have our Activation so
we have activation we could say sigmoid
we have the sigmoid activation since
we're replicating uh the relu or rather
the Lunette architecture so there we go
we have the sigmoid and that's our
conf2d from the curve 2D we have a Max
pulling layer let's take this off let's
take this dance layers off from the
scarf 2D we have the max pool and layer
now what we could do is we could just
simply import all this so let's go ahead
and say
import.com 2D Max pool 2D and the dance
layer
coming back to our documentation we
could check out on the Max Pro 2D so
there we go we have Max Port 2D
we'll specify the pole size which is
equal to and then the number of Stripes
equal to adding is valid and data format
we're not going to specify that so we
have our Max Port 2D and then the
sporting size with the stripes we copy
that
we actually didn't know the stride of
two so we replace that we have a stride
of two The Next Step
is this one right here similar to what
we had seen previously with the
difference that now we have 16 number of
filters and so we could simply copy this
and then paste this out right here we
have come to the max pool 2D now conf 2D
Max Pro 2D and then here we have 16
number of filters the pattern is valid
activation sigmoid then this next Max
Pro 2D is still the same as what we had
previously and so we'll move on to the
flattened layer
we add this here we have flatten
there we go and we run that so while
that's running we just simply come right
here and then add that flattened layer
so we have this flattened layer which is
in charge of flattering this or
converting this into this 1D output from
this flatten we now have a dense layer
which is what we've seen already so we
just have to put this dense layer here
this like this and there we go so we
have our dance layer and then the
activation is sigmoid so we're
respecting the activation using the
Lunette paper then we have this here we
take a thousand and then we have that we
add another Advanced layer at this other
dance layer now we'll make sure that as
we
create this final dance layer right here
it has an output of two neurons since
we are dealing with a binary
classification problem
so that's fine take this here and then
run our model
we're having that input layer is not
defined so let's simply add that here we
have the input layer
run that and then
check that out again
there we go we have this input layer
which we run which we add and then we
run this now everything is fine so
that's it we have 45 million parameters
um and no non-trainable parameter
notice how the this dense layer here is
responsible for
a huge percentage of our parameters so
we could reduce this let's take this to
a hundred and then this to like 10.
let's run that again and there we go we
have a smaller model this time around
a point to note is this number of
parameters which we pre-calculated here
here we have 456 and here we have 2460.
and we'll see how we get exactly this
number of values here for the dense
layer it's quite obvious as we just have
a hundred times ten plus the 10 biasis
giving us 100 times 10 is 1000 plus 10
giving us a thousand and ten and then
here we have 10 times 2 20 20 plus 2
bias is giving us 22. it should also be
noted that there was a slight error here
as we don't have like with this we have
five by five by three but here is five
by five by six since we have the input
number of channels equals six so this
means this is five by five by six and
here is five by five by three all those
five by five by three and all just five
by five by six and if you take five by
five by six and multiply it 16 times you
should have
2416. it should be noted that here we're
trying to replicate the Lunette
architecture and this is in no way this
state of the art kinds of models we use
today so in the section on the creative
measures we are going to use even better
models for now let's just work with this
we are now building a model let's now
move on to the error sanctioning section
for
error sanction and binary classification
problems we generally use the binary
cross entropy loss let's look at this
formula of the binary cross entropy loss
from those ml cheap website
just as most error sanctioning functions
with the binary cross entropy we're
trying to penalize the model when the
actual prediction is different from the
predicted value
and so in this case of a binary
classification problem if our actual
prediction is meant to be a one and our
model predicts zero putting this in here
would have
one
log zero
so we have one log zero
and then here we have one minus one one
minus one is zero so we have your zero
one minus one log of one since p is zero
so we have one minus one log of one
if we plot out the curve for the log we
would have something like this
we have this plot right here here is one
and then we notice that as we are
approaching zero that's X
and then here we have y equals log of x
and as we are approaching zero that's as
X is 10 into a zero would have this log
which is going towards negative infinity
and so the log of zero is a very large
number
now with this case we have zero so this
is sticking off and so this means when
the actual prediction is one and the
predicted value is zero our final output
becomes a large number
now let's uh modify this let's say we
have zero here and then yeah we have one
in this case we would have a similar
scenario because here we're gonna have
for the y y zero so you have zero zero
times whatever it will have here will be
zero so we'll have zero here and then
here we would have
um one because one minus y let's erase
this one minus y
take this off 1 minus y in this case
would give us one since we have zero
here and then we have log of 1 minus p p
is one so we have log of zero and again
we have a large value because log of
zero is taking us towards negative
infinity and then we have one times that
big number giving us a big number and so
our model is sanctioned because it
hasn't correctly predicted the
expected output and then suppose in the
actual prediction is one and that our
model actually predicts one in that case
we would have year one so we have one
log of one and then we have one minus
one so here we have one minus one and
then log of one minus one that's uh log
of zero but here we have one minus one
which is zero so zero times this will
cancel out and then what we'll be left
with will be this
and as you could see here when x equal 1
log of x equals zero so log one is zero
and then we have a final answer of zero
so our final output here is zero telling
us that with the model that's done its
job correctly if you do the same for
when actually zero and previous zero
you'll see that you always have this
here zero now note that this um zero log
zero is actually a standard limit but we
wouldn't get into that and you could
check on
uh calculus cost to better understand
that for now just know that this will
give you zero and then yeah we have also
zero so our final output is zero and our
model
now makes use of the binary cross
entropy loss to update its weights so if
we have a zero and then let's say we
have 0.8 right here we compute this BCE
as a binary cross entropy loss y true y
red
there we go you see we have this value
of 1.6 now let's
modify this so let's have
um say
0.02 I will run that you see we leave
from 1.6 to 0.02 and then if we take say
0.2
you see we have this
now you could always Stack Up outputs as
we had in the beginning so let's have
back this outputs and then we have BCE y
true y red and run that again you see we
have this value here
for our loss and then if we take this to
one you see now we have here zero one
you see the loss is increased
another argument we could pass in here
is a from logit's argument you could
check on the other arguments and
documentation for the form largest
argument by default it's actually false
but then
this default value of false is supposing
that the output of our model the Y bread
will always produce values in the range
0 1. now the way our model has been
constructed ensures that all our values
will be produced in that range because
we have the sigmoid right here and if
you could recall we had the sigmoid
which was like this so whatever sigmoid
we have this function which looked like
this
and that
as we increased the value of x the
output was going towards one so as we
increase the value of x output goes plus
one as X becomes very small or take a
very large negative number X goes
towards zero so in fact it's going to
always ensure that the output lies
between 0 and 1. that's why it's very
important to have the sigmoid here now
in the case where this we don't have the
sigma that is our output doesn't
necessarily lie between the round one
what we're gonna do is say that we're
gonna use from logits equal true so
specifying from log is equal to True
simplest means you are trying to say you
are not sure that your output or your
model output will always fall in the
range 0 1.
now I have said if we run this
you see we have a totally different
response
so you have to be very careful when
working with this if your values range
between 0 and 1 make sure you use the
default from logit's equal false from
here let's go ahead and compile our
model we have Optimizer we have the loss
our losses the binary cross entropy last
so here we have binary
binary cross entropy there we go and
then the metrics for now let's take this
off so we just comment this part for now
we're not going to take that into
consideration so that's it we've
compiled our model so we could run this
compile our model and then it's not
defined let's go ahead and Define all
this
and I'm now defined let's take this
Matrix off and then we have the binary
cross entropy binary cross entropy there
we go we run that we're running this now
everything works fine
and so we go ahead and train our model
in a similar way we had done previously
right here we have our Dream Theater and
our validation data let's also reduce
this learning rate let's run that and
then we start with the training
we have this error which reads logits
and labels must have the same shape this
shape is given versus this one now we'll
try to understand
together while we're having this error
so let's
go right up to the model creation
now when creating the data set I'll
when processing this data set
we had
this kinds of
inputs and outputs
for the inputs we have 224 by 224x3 and
for the output we had just one
and this was because our output could
take either a zero or a one
but the werewolf Define our model is
slightly different
with this model definition we actually
have a shape
year of two
so let's take this we actually have a
shape of two
meaning that we could have two
outputs whereas the the way our data set
was constructed it was such that we
could only have one output when our
output is zero we suppose that it's
parasitized and when our output is one
it is uninfected
and so because of this we are going to
modify our code such that this output
here is one let's run that again and
there we go so we've modified our model
we compile recompile our model and then
we get to train our model
we still have the same error but this
comes from the fact that we change this
name from model to the net model so that
when working with other models we could
always
find ourselves so we have learned that
model and then here is learn net model
Lunette model so that's it we run it
again and that should be fine so uh
We've started out without training
process
you see we're training but this looks
very slow let's check on the run time so
let's click on change runtime type
Hardware accelerator and we see noon so
we actually using a CPU here of which we
should be using the GPU so that's it
let's check on this and then let's
select GPU so that's fine now and we
save
we will run that again
we throw this model is not defined and
this is because every time you change
this runtime you have to restart all
this so let's rerun this and then get to
the training
the training process is now much faster
than what we had previously as you could
notice and this is because we're now
using a GPU
after train we have this error now the
fact that
um the model trains and then gets right
up to the end of the ebook before 20's
error should give us a hint that most
probably this error is coming from the
validation set because for the training
everything went well and then at the end
where some validation has to be computed
to give us the validation loss we have
an error this means that that validation
data set hasn't has a problem so here we
have validation training data set
without data set and then
what we notice is that these two are
slightly different so here we've not
done the resizing we've not yet done the
processing of the validation set as we
did with the train data set so let's get
back and check on that so right here we
have this
um we have this let's add this code and
repeat this for the validation and the
test set
so that's what we get and here is it
let's ensure that we had no
pre-processing before this so here we
had this
um train so we have to repeat the same
for the validation everything we do with
the train we do the same with the
validation and coming back up here we
have okay everything is okay so here we
need to make sure that the screen and
validation have the same pre-processing
we have the train and then the
validation so we have validation and
your validation
I will repeat the same tool for the test
so we have test data set
equal test it is set the map resize and
Rescue
that's fine we run that
and then we go ahead and check now on
this next one
here we have the batch size defined
between shuffling and batching and
prefetching so yeah let's take this off
since it's already defined we have the
validation
here is validation
[Music]
there we go validation and that should
be fine so we have the validation
which has been processed so we've done
this we run this and then we have the
tests we do the same for the test
but when we kick this out we see that we
are trying to shuffle this test which is
actually a very useless operation since
we do not want to shuffle our test set
and then we do not also want to do this
button so this tool already useless and
then the prefetching useless so
practically we don't need to do this for
the test set so that's fine and then we
have train and then validation train
validation data set we run that and here
we go now we have this known and known
here because we have
completed this batching the first time
for the training and then we've redone
this again so it's like a batch on a
batch that's why we have this so we have
to get back and make sure that we're
working from this so we have to
rerun this to make sure we have
this train data set calculated again
so now we have our Trend data set which
has been completed from the original
data set and everything should be fine
done that and
we'll visualized
resize our skill yeah this this could be
done too for the testing so that's why
we allow this because we need to resize
and rescue for our test set so we have
that fine and then
here we go we run this right here run
this validation and train you see
everything is now okay so we have that
that's fine uh model we have a model
it's needless actually we initialized in
our model since we've already started
with training so we just keep it from
here but for demonstration purposes
let's just rerun this again so we've
been training for a while and we're
getting this very poor result we notice
how the loss isn't changing at all for
the validation it's kind of similar
situation we're having this changes
between five four four five and that's
it another thing you could do to make
this debugging faster is well for now
take off the validation so let's take
this out for now and then let's stop the
streaming
we now make some changes to a model
right here where we instead of having
this activation we have relu and then
here we have this relu
right here we have relu
there we go we have relu and this is a
sigmoid
we would also want to reduce the size of
this receptive Fields so take the
current size of three and your kernel
size three
so that's it let's rerun this and see
what we get
there we go we run that and now we don't
have the validation so training should
go faster
we'll see again here that nothing has
really changed with the training so
let's interrupt this and get back to our
model
there we go we have our model we're now
going to include batch normalization
in batch normalization values of the
same all values belonging to the same
batch
are standardized so we have X becoming x
minus the mean mu
divided by the standard deviation
so that's it let's add this batch
normalization layer like your batch
normalization there we go we have the
batch normalization after this golf 2D
again we have batch Norm analyzation
and then for the dance we have batch
normalization
we do the same for this let's not forget
the Commerce so we should have this here
and I have this here
let's copy this and then paste it out
here we have patch normalization so
that's fine we have included battery
normalization
we will run the model
back normalization not defined let's
have this here we have batch
normalization there we go so we take
this and then we run our model
running this
that should be fine
our model is now recompiled so we
recompile our model and then we fit the
model what do we notice we have this
last which now drops normally
and so we'll see how important it is to
work with a batch normalization layer
apart from this the Bice normalization
layer serves as a regularizer and we'll
see that subsequently
given that our model is now training
properly we could halt this training
process and then include performance
measurement so here we have the metrics
and we have accuracy so our performance
metric here is accuracy and we'll we run
this so when training will be able to
see how the loss and the accuracy board
evolve
there we go we recompile the model and
we go back to training a model's
accuracy is equal the total number of
times that model predicted an output
correctly divided by the total number of
predictions this means if we have a
model right here let's say we have Model
A right here and then we have another
model C model B and that we allow these
two models to carry out say a thousand
predictions so we have totally 1 000
predictions now if Model A does
800 correct predictions then its
accuracy is 800 divided by a thousand
now you could put this as a fraction or
in percentage so here we have 80 percent
accuracy
now if we have model B which does 980
correct predictions so we have this
accuracy of 98 for B and in this case
we'll say that model B outperforms Model
A it should be noted that the accuracy
has a performance metric isn't always
the best choice of a performance metric
when it comes to classification problems
as others like the Precision the recall
the f1's car and many others exist for
now we'll use the accuracy and later on
we'll look at the other metrics which we
could use when we're dealing with
classification problems after training
through 20 ebooks we have this results
here now let's plot this out so let's
plot our loss and then plot the accuracy
we have these two plots there we go we
see that the
training and validation losses but
keep dropping and then the accuracy tool
keeps increasing though the train
accuracy is slightly greater than that
of the validation accuracy
our next move will be to evaluate our
model so let's go ahead we have learned
that model dot evaluate we evaluate this
model and here's what we get we receive
this error telling us that there is an
incompatibility
with the expected shape
and the shape of this test data set
right here so recall that when building
the test data set that was around this
position when building tested is set we
didn't uh include this batching so let's
just do that straight away we have let's
add a code cell and that's it so here we
have test data set now before doing that
let's print this out first let's clean
out the test data set and you see the
train data set so we have that you'll
notice that with the train we have this
batch Dimension whereas here we don't
have that so to include that we have
tested set equals test data set and then
we include a batch of one since we just
testing on uh single elements so we have
that we run it and there we go so here
if we run test did it set this time
around see we should have this batch
damage now let's go ahead and evaluate
our model there we go on theater this
model has never seen it has
94.16 accuracy and a loss of 0.2 this
sounds interesting and note that we
could continue with this training so you
could train for more ebooks as compared
to this and many scientists have met
this remark where sometimes the forget
to stop the training and then the
comeback and notice that they have
gotten an even better performance model
because they allow that model to train
for longer time after evaluating our
model let's look at how to do model
predictions now the whole idea of model
predictions
makes sense since we have trained our
model inputs and outputs and then now we
want to pass in an input and let our
model automatically come out or come up
with the output that is to say whether
the image contains
a parasitized cell or an uninfected cell
that said all we need to do right here
is our model.predict so we have this
predict method right here and then we
pass in our data in this case we have
test data set and then we take one value
that's it then we pick this up now we
run that
model not defined we have Lynnette and
so that's it we're told that this is an
uninfected cell
now we'll Define this method parasite or
not which is defined such that if we
have an input X then that if the if that
X is less than 0.5 we consider that we
have a parasitized cell and if it's
greater than or equals 0.5 then it's an
uninfected cell recall that the way the
data was created was such that
parasitized was zero and then uninfected
was one so uh we are having a threshold
value of 0.5 the threshold value is
defined now such that every value less
than 8 is considered parasitized and
everybody greater than it is considered
uninfected so that's it
if you now replace here with parasite or
not
outside or not and we run this again
we are told that this is uninfected we
are gonna do the testing on nine
different elements so right here we take
nine of this and then we do the subplots
first we do the image show and we
specify this because we don't want to
batch Dimension and then we have the
title and this title we have the actual
output and we have the models predicted
output
now that said we run this guys what we
get we'll see that for this year we have
uu so the actual represented is but
uninfected you you you here we have u p
meaning that the actual is uninfected by
the predicts uh are size here we have PP
correct u-u-p-p u u and PP thank you for
getting to this point in our next
section we'll look at corrective
measures so we'll look at how to load
and save our model how to build other
types of models using different apis how
to use different kinds of metrics
visualizing what our model sees using
callbacks data augmentation Dropout
regularization at least tarpine batch
normalization instance normalization
layer normalization weight
initialization learning rate shadowing
custom losses and metrics and sampling
methods custom Training
tensor bar and Hyper parameter tuning
weights and biases logs weights and
biases artifacts and finally wasting
biases sweeps that said see you next
time
in our previous section we've built a
deep learning model based on
convolutional neural networks to help
detect the presence of malaria in blood
cells nonetheless in the real world we
are not always going to be using
our models on a collab notebook like
this
hence we need to be able to save this
model so it could be used externally
in this section we'll learn how to save
and load model and also do the same
process with Google Drive that is we'll
be able to save our model in our Google
Drive and then later on when we want to
use this model we just load it from our
Google Drive that's it don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification
button so you don't miss amazing content
like this we'll build this very
performant model though we could improve
on it but then once we close this we do
not save this model's current state and
so if we have to come next time the
model will have randomly initialized
weights which will be different from the
weights we've got now after training on
this data set
another issue is in case we want to use
this model in another scenario or in
another environment like say on a
browser or on a mobile phone
will need to find a way to export this
model from here and so tensorflow allows
us to save our model now we'll have to
differentiate between uh models
configuration and models weights so a
model like this let's suppose we have a
model which is defined as such we have
the input which we pass into account
layer and then we have batch
normalization we have pooling for soft
sampling and then we flatten and after
flattening we pass to a dense layer and
we have our output so suppose we have
this small model now
all the parameters
for the creation of this model are known
as the models configuration the models
configuration we may have it that the
model for example like in this case here
the model starts with a conf layer with
six filters you know size three batch
norm and all this so these are our
models configurations
but this model's configurations are
different from the model's weights the
model's weights are those filters
we have for example in the case of the
conf 2D so we have the model weights and
the model's configuration
and upon summarizing the model we see
clearly here that we have this comp 2D
and then we have this number of
parameters
and so whenever want to save a model we
have to take into consideration this
configuration and the weights because
for this same configuration we could
have different weights
and so there are actually two main
options the first option is to save the
full model that is to save the model
configuration and the model weights
another option will be to save only the
model weights so we could save all the
model weights now this option is used
when for example we don't want to or we
don't even know this model configuration
up front so
um we have used this here we've defined
a models configuration we've trained it
we've got a new weights and this the
current model state but if we take this
to another environment where we don't
have this configuration then if we've
saved this model's configuration and
weights all we need to do
is just to load this configuration and
weights which have been packaged as the
full model
now in another case where we are able to
get the configuration and all we need is
just the weights then we'll just uh save
the weights and then reload this weights
since we already have the configuration
either ways we will always need the
configuration and the weights
nonetheless it's important to note that
the most important part of this is
actually the weights since working with
a randomized or randomly initialized
weights after we've trained our model
isn't very useful and sometimes we may
take many days to train this model so
imagine you've trained your model for
like 10 days and then you want to reuse
that model and the weights have been
randomly initialized you find that those
10 days have been wasted but time wise
and monetary wise so you have to ensure
that you save your waste properly such
that you could reuse them and then the
great thing with tensorflow is you could
also continue training from the state so
this means that at this point where
we've gotten this models
um performance here where we have 94 we
could keep training from here so that we
could get even to say 99 percent
so you have to ensure that your saving
is done properly now let's get into that
but before getting to that one last
point also note that with the first
method
here with this first method
apart from this model configurations we
also have information like the metrics
so the metrics you use like the accuracy
uh the loss you use uh the optimizers so
the optimizer information you use and
all that so this kind of hyper parameter
information has been saved here so next
time all you need to do is just to load
your model and then make use of it
whereas here all your saving is just the
weights
that said let's see if our model this
case we have learned model uh dot save
actually then it model dot save and we
give you the name so we see the net save
model for example that's it now we have
this the net safe model or we run that
cell and we check this out you know so
we check out those files and what do you
see you have this linear safe model
folder in this folder you have the
assets which in this case is empty you
have the variables
which actually contains the weights so
you could download this from here to
download this and then upload it next
time so from here you see click on
download that's fine we have the
variables which contains the weights
that's it and then we have this uh saved
model dot protobar file here which
actually contains our configuration
we've had our configuration saved and
our weights saved now let's uh load this
so we'll save this and now we can now
load it uh note that you could always
download this so you could download the
weights right here download this so
let's click on download
to download all this and then next time
all you need to do is just to load it
now let's go ahead and load this
the loading is quite simple here we'll
Define a new model the net loaded we
have loaded model equals tf.keras dot
models dot load model there we go and
now we specify is this exact same name
we have Lynnette saved model now what
we'll do is we're going to
um do Lynette loaded model and then
summary so that's it we're gonna run
that and
we get in this Arrow here which is
unusual
um changing this name actually makes
this work so the net and then here so we
have this Lunette and let's run that
again we save that
and then we load this
and we have our model right here so this
means
if you have to come back to this
notebook all you need is to
um load this model which hasn't saved
right here in this little net folder
and so just like with this we'll replace
this Lunette model by Lynnette loaded
model so let's load this let's use this
loaded model and do some predictions
there we go yes we'll get you you PP PPP
here we have an error uu and PP so it's
kind of hmm
similar to what we have with the
original model
from here we could also evaluate this
model we have learned loaded model we
evaluate that and let's see what we get
recall previously we had 94.16 so now we
expect to have something around that
value
there we go we have exactly the same
output as previously
now we are going to look at how to load
and save with the hdf5 format now this
hdfight format is
a lightweight version of this tensorflow
model saving method yeah those are only
this slight difference all we need to do
is to say or include this file extension
so we have your HD HD F5 and then we
save that now you check this out you
should have the hdf5 appearance so here
we have the lunet hdf5 and then you
could see its weight by 53 megabytes now
let's load this model to load it
what we have here is the same code we
had previously and then here we specify
hdf5 so there we go we run that and we
have exactly the same summary so that's
it now we're here to work with custom
layers that you have to note that in the
case where you've built custom layers
then those configurations aren't start
when you're dealing with this hdf5
format and so that's why uh generally
it's preferable for you to use this
first formatting with we presented
that said we're done with this first
method where we saved the configurations
and the weights now let's look at this
next method where we see only the
weights so in this case for example
where we're having this notebook what we
could do is simply just save the weights
given that we already have the models
configuration defined in here so let's
get straight away into looking at those
safe weights method which comes with
tensorflow so take that off
and then right here we have Lynnette
model which we defined already and then
we save this weights as the net weight
so here we've saved this weights let's
put it in the folder so we have the
weights folder we run that again so we
could see clearly our weights
um click on that and there we go we have
our weights and this weights we have the
check pointing we have the weights now
notice how this weights here that's in
this variables if you click on this
variables
okay so notice how there is some
similarity between what we had here and
this notice how this is the same as this
and then this index here is the same as
this here because we said that this
variables contain the weights now we
have the checkpoints uh subsequently
we're gonna look at checkpoints and with
tensorflow so for now just know that
this is how we save the weights and then
uh up on defining your model so you've
defined your model you can now load just
this weight and not the whole model but
loading the weights you're saying that
you don't want the optimization or the
optimizer configuration you don't want
the metrics and you don't want the last
configurations so that's it let's look
at how to load this weights now here's
all we need to load the weights we have
the Lynette model the load weights and
then we load this weights let's do this
so you see clearly that oh this loading
actually works so the first thing we're
do is we are going to reinitialize our
model so we'll rerun this so we rerun
this we'll compile our model and then we
run this evaluation right here so we
evaluate the model and so you see that
when the models wait are randomly
initialized we have very poor results
so there we go after random
initialization we have this now what
we'll do is we'll take our Lunette model
and then we load the weights so we're
gonna load the weights and then pass in
our weights slash the net weights
that's fine let's run this again and
then get a new models performance there
we go we see that our model now gets
back to the
94.16 accuracy we had initially after
doing the training at this point we've
been able to load and save our model
right here on Google collab but as we
know at the end of the session or after
closing my notebook
all this information will be lost so
let's see how to save this information
in Google Drive we'll start by importing
this drive so we'll have from Google dot
drive from google.com we're going to
import the drive let's run that
and then the next thing we'll do is to
mount this drive so we have drive.mount
and then we specify the location so we
have your drive and running that
you will be asked to put in an
authorization code right here to get
this authorization code it suffice to
click on this right this link given to
us here so we'll click on that link and
then once this pops up we have this you
select your account
once you select an account you now go to
connection so you've connected and then
you copy your code so your code is
copied now you put it in here and then
you press enter
once that's fine
you see we have here mounted at content
slash drive so mountain in this location
You Could See Clearly from here and this
tells us we are in this directory
content and then desire to content we've
created this other directory drive now
we click this open and then uh from this
I can get access to my own Google Drive
if now I want to copy this Linette
folder into my Google Drive so that next
time I could just load it from my Google
Drive
I'll make use of
this CP Command right here so what we'll
have is
um CP some option and then we have the
SARS and the destination so here we are
going to specify or we are going to use
this
um R so recursive so we're gonna use
this to copy directories recursively and
that's it
we run the command we have this
here and then we specify this folders
directory here so we have content and
then Lunette so we copying this Lunette
and then to our destination to my drive
so we specify my drive we have my drive
and then in here I have learn nets all I
just said the net collab so that's it
from here I'm gonna run this my drive
and then I'll search for the neck collab
so that's what I have now I have this
little net collab right here and then
our next step will be to copy from the
my drive to the Google app such that
um next time in case where we have not
for example save this year we'll be able
to just quickly get that information
from the drive onto the Google app also
note that this is really used to with
these sets so what we could have here is
the it is set and I'll collab and then
we could transfer that data set to a
drive and vice versa now let's do the
same thing so here we're gonna copy this
back but this time around we're gonna
copy this into
Lunette collab so we're going to create
a new photo here the net collab and then
take this information so this number
we're copying from
our drive into the net collab so that's
it and then the net collab we'll run
that
and let's click on this click again and
guess what we see we have our learner
collab right here
thank you very much for following up to
this point and see you next time
hello everyone and welcome to this new
section in which we'll look at different
ways of creating models other than the
sequential API which we've seen so far
in this section we'll look at the
functional API we'll look at building
collable models we'll look at building
model of your subclassing will also look
at building our own custom layers
previously in the scars we said that
there are three ways in which models are
built in tensorflow that is the
sequential API
using the functional API and then
finally model subclassing as of this
point we have been using the sequential
API as you could see right here
now you may ask yourself why do we need
to use a different method in creating
tensorflow models when so far we've
achieved close to 99 percent trained
accuracy and around 95 percent test
accuracy
now as you may have noticed so far all
the models we've been brewed in have
taken up this kind of structure where we
have an input we have the first layer
the next layer which has been stacked
in this sequential manner right up to
this very last layer here and then we
have the output
so the question we could ask ourselves
is what if we have a model which takes
in say two inputs and has three outputs
these kinds of models are very
purple line deep learning and we shall
look at them subsequently but before
getting there you could just imagine a
problem where instead of classifying
whether we have a non-parasitic or a
parasitic cell we wanna
know the exact position of that
parasitic cell or in general that cell
in the image you would find that you
would have one output which classifies
whether it's a parasitic or not so we
have this first output parasitic or
uninfected and then this other output
which gives us the position of the cell
or the exact position of the cell in the
image so here we see already how we
could get two outputs from this let's
take this third output out so here we
see we could have let's let's even take
this one so here we have this one output
to Output model and with a sequential
API we can't really do this so that's
why working with a functional API is
very important
the next point is we'll be able to
create more complex models with the
functional API so there is this model
known as the resnet which is very
popular in deep learning uh computer or
deep learning for computer vision now A
restaurant like structure will look like
this we have this Mark this layer uh
this outputs have been passing to this
next layer and then we have
the outputs of this
which are going to be concatenated with
these outputs
and then after this concatenation we are
going to pass this to the next layer
right here so if you want to add this
layer we could have a layer here
and have that so as we're saying we take
this output and then concatenate it with
this next output we'll pass into this
next layer and so this kinds of
structures or those kinds of models
could not be built with the sequential
API and hence the need for the
functional API and then the last reason
why we are gonna
be using the functional API
is the fact that we could use shared
layers with shared layers we could have
a layer or particular layer in our model
which has already a predefined way of
encoding information so when we pass
information let's say we have this input
let's say input one when we pass this
input one this layer right here or this
encoder produces an output
which is going to be different from when
we pass in another input I2
but the way it produces its outputs is
in a very thoughtful manner so we could
have i1 I2 I3 which all share this layer
and then we have all the layers of the
model which you follow on
that said we'll look at how to create
the functional API so here we have the
sequential and then just below we are
going to create this functional API
before starting all the creation we are
going to import some classes so start by
importing the input class right here
which is a layer we import input and
then we have
from tensorflow Keras layer or rather
models we're going to import
model so we import the model right here
and we import the input we run this and
actually find
we now have this funk input since we're
using the functional API this way of
calling that we have the fund input and
then we have input which we just called
and this sticks in the shape so here
we're gonna copy this exact shape we use
in the sequential API we have the shape
right here
there we go we copy that shape and then
we reuse it here and create in this
input layer so here we have that and
then we have your shape so we've had the
shape this point you could start
stacking up all these different layers
we had stacked up in the sequential or
with this when we're using the
sequential API we started with this here
this comes 2D right up to this dense
layer so there we go we're just gonna
make use of this so we copy that and
then we are going to paste this out
right here now first things first we
have an output so first since we have
this layer that we have this conf2d
which we've defined and then we pass in
the output from this input layer so here
we have this funk input we copy that and
then we pass this into this
into this kind of layer right here now
once it passes into this conf layer we
have an output and that output is this X
and then uh you should guess that right
we pass this x into this back Norm layer
so here we have X as you could see and
then we have an output of X there we go
from here we pass in the X into the max
pool Max pool to the layer so we have
this we cut that and then we have this x
right here so we'll just repeat this
same process right up to the end and
there we go you see that we haven't done
much changes or as compared with the
sequential API so that's it we pass in
this input right here we have X we pass
it in we have this we pass in and right
up to This n now once we get to the end
we are now going to create the Lynette
model from the so we have learned model
equal model which will import it and
then we have the funk input
now yeah let's say we have Funk output
so we'll pass this last and then our
last output is from output so we have
the input and then we have the output so
there we go we can now give it a name we
have name learn net model
um if we look up we have Mr Clean Ryan
within this right here so this should be
the input image here we have our input
image and then we've created our model
the net model and then from here you
could simply do learned model dot
summary now you'll notice that we should
have exactly the same
summary as we have with the sequential
API so let's run that and see what we
get
yeah we have how many parameters we have
um four million 668 297 parameters
there we go you see we have exactly the
same number of parameters the same
number of trainable and non-trainable
parameters so basically what we've done
here is we've recreated this model we
created with a sequential API
now we've gotten this we'll see that we
have to change absolutely nothing to my
code so yeah we're just gonna compile
our model without changing anything we
have the same Lynette model now we could
also change this let's say in that funk
so you see clearly that we are actually
using this functional model right here
so we have this funk there we go
Funk and that's it we'll go around that
and then
we recompile right here so we are not
changing any parts of this we compile
that and then we
train the model
we are getting this Arrow because of the
way we named this model right here so
let's have this the net model that's
fine
we we compile and then we run
so that's it we're training our model
and here is what we get as results
now coming back to our model we'll see
that we have this feature extraction
unit right here so this
conf layers are responsible for
extracting useful features from the
images and then this last layers are
responsible for correctly classifying
whether the image is parasitic or not
that set we could build a model
known as feature extractor and so here
we'll add this
we have our model feature extractor
which is going to be like similar
in construction as what we've done so
far so we just have that copied and then
we have this but the difference is we
are not going to include this other this
final layers right here we'll only end
at this point and then we'll
have us output this year so this is our
functional here we'll call this
extractor let's let's just say we have
this is output so we have this output
and there we go so here we have our
functional input and then we have this
output
and then here's the feature extractor so
we have our feature extractor model
right here
we could um do this feature extractor
and then we summarize this so let's run
this and see what we get so that's it we
have our input and then we have this
output right here
at this point
instead of writing all this we wrote
here we're just gonna call or let's
let's take from this point so we have
our feature
let's look at the name we gave it we
gave it the name feature extractor model
so here we have feature
extractor
model so yes our fixture extractor model
see we take all this off and then
here we pass in our input so notice how
we are making this model look like a
function so
tensorflow models are callable just like
the layers
and as you could see here this feature
extractor model
could be seen as a layer just like the
dense layer the batch num layer and all
other layers so we've gotten this X from
this input which has been passed in our
model and then from here you see we pass
this x into this flatten and we have the
rest so that's it let's now rerun this
again so you could see what we get as
output and as you could see we get
exactly what we expected we have the
same number of parameters and there is
this difference here where we have this
feature extractor so unlike before where
we had the conf Nets like the conf2d
batch and all Max Boolean and the same
like let's go up here there's actually a
feature extractor so unlike before we
have this and then this now it has been
replaced with this feature extractor
right here that set we've just built
this model using the functional API and
in subsequent sections will build even
more complex models using this
functional API models where we're going
to use shared layers we're going to have
multiple inputs multiple outputs and
models we are going to have even more
complicated model configurations it's
important to note that you could mix up
the functional API model creation Style
with that of the sequential API
so here instead of creating this so
instead of having this uh feature
extractor created like this we are going
to create it using the sequential API
let's add that and then we copy out this
from your
copy out this full model with a
sequential API put this out and we take
another feature extraction part
here you see we take this off and then
we left only with this feature
extraction part now let's call this
feature extractor
so feature extractor
sequential model there we go
pieces out right here
and we're fine so we have our feature
extractor model
run that that's okay
let's take this off
and then we'll just
make sure we put exactly the same here
so there we go we paste it out and we
rerun this
Let's see we should be able to get
exactly the same output see we have
exactly the same output and your instead
of our future extractor model we have
your sequential layer so that's it
this shows us that we could mix up this
different ways of creating models
from this point we'll look at the models
of Classen so right here we have our
models of classroom
there we go it's important to note that
models of class and permits us to create
recursively composible layers and models
now what does that mean
this means I could create a layer where
its attributes are other layers and this
layer
tracks the weights and biases of the sub
layers
before taking an example let's make this
in part so we're going to import layer
from layers we have tensorflow dot Keras
dot layers we're gonna import layer
we run that and then we move on to
create our
model using the model subclassing
now that said we have this feature our
feature extractor so we have feature
extractor right here and then this
inherits from layer so you inherit from
tensorflow layer and then we have
and init method and followed by a call
method so that's it now let's use the
right syntax here is a class here is a
method you need method
there we go you could always check on
our free cars on Python Programming in
case you're not versed with all this
syntax so that's it we've had that and
now just like the way we did when we're
creating this feature extractor let's go
back to our future extractor
um with a functional API actually here
you'll see let's copy this out
and then get back to our model
subclassing so that's it
um here let's just put this down here
and then we have the super
feature extractor
there we go that you need
so that's it now that we have defined
this we could now go ahead
and use this layers as the attribute for
this feature extractor layer
so there we go we have this year we have
our cons the
self.self.com one which is this conf2d
right here so we pick all this off and
just place it here and then from here we
have
um the batch batch one which is this
batch Norm layer right here take this
and then place it right here we have the
Max Pro 2D
take that off we have South dot pool
one
there we go so that's it and then we
just repeat this process so we could
have the self that counts one count two
rather so count two and then we just
take up this parameters let's take this
from here
and place it right here so here instead
of having this we will just get this and
then the bachelor Max bolts will remain
the same so that's it for init method we
now go ahead to build a call method we
have our call method here which takes
this input X and then here what it does
is
it permits us call each and every layer
of
defined your in this init method so here
we have
x equals self so the value of x is going
to change you're going to pass it
yourself that counts one and server is
going to take an X this looks similar to
the functional API we have x equals cell
dot batch one
there we go
um batch one and then we have x equals
self dot pull one
X
equals self.com two
and then self dot batch two
and finally we have self Dot
pull two
that's it so now from here we just
return X
also note that we could uh pass in a
parameter an argument like the training
which can tell us whether to use a given
layer or not during the training process
nonetheless for now all this is going to
be used during training so we have that
now let's take all this off
we run that there we go
um that's run correctly now we should be
able to build our model so here we have
this Lynnette model which took the
feature extractor model from here
um let's just copy this and then but
before copying that we have to ensure
that we
create this year so we have future
subclass
so we have all features of plast which
is this feature extractor would build
right here
so here we have feature extractor to
build so that's it now you could always
pass this parameters like the number of
filters the kennel size via this so you
could pass this year you could specify
filters and and the kernel size so let's
let's just do that so let's say filter
sticks kernel size
um strikes and say adding and Activation
so if we could pass all this here so
that when we get to this point we just
we don't need to specify all this
we will simply take this off
or no need to specify all this anymore
um now we have our activation all that
specified okay we could also include the
pool size
those include the pool size
and all this strides here okay so let's
just say you're gonna have two times the
strikes because we always specify the
strides to be one so let's take this off
um yeah we're gonna have two attempt
strides and we've defined here we have
the pool size so let's take this off
and take
let's take this off rather let's let's
get back so we take this off and take
this out so that's it we've defined all
that and now we're ready to pass all
these values so just simply copy all
those values and then in your we'll
specify the number of filters so yeah
let's take eight the kernel size let's
take three the number of strides we have
one the pattern here is valid valid
activation
[Music]
so that's it so we've defined all this
now at this point let's ensure that we
have this times two
so let's run this now
again and then we have our feature
extractor that we get in this error
let's try to understand why and how to
solve this error
so there we go scroll in we have this
now the reason why we have this error is
because of the order in which this conf
2D Texas arguments
so if you look at this trying to get
this um to come up anyway we just look
at the documentation you see we have
filters kennel size strides pattern
um data format so you see we have the
data format the slit the dilation rate
groups before the activation so it's
important that
um we specify that this is Filters equal
filters then you ever specify kind of
science equal kernel size
if not it's going to take this to be the
data format so that's it strides padding
equal padding
activation equal Activation so this
should be fine now we run that again
we have this Arrow but this time it runs
for the second conf layer so let's let's
just redo what we had done here
and take this off
notice field to size times two so here
we have filters times two
we try to do same for the max pool 2D so
here we have both sides equal
size
that was it
um strikes that's fine and then yeah we
have both sides are called pool size
okay so now everything should work fine
we run that
and there we go everything works fine so
now we've created a layer of feature
subclass layer we will now be able to
use it in this model right here so let's
copy that and then get back to this oh
this is out here and now here we have
our features
let's take all this off
subclassed and then we could comfortably
run this and
we get in this error now let's get back
to check uh we see batch two there's an
error level Bash 2. now you see here we
have this two this should be two and
this should be two so that's fine let's
run that again
and everything works well so you see it
gives us exact same up we expect to get
with this feature extractor right here
then one last thing we could do is
instead of doing this way let's insert
some code instead of doing this way we
are going to create a model using this
models of placing method so here we just
let's copy this out
so we copy that out and then in your
instead of having layers so yeah we're
not having a layer we have a model
so instead of having layer we now have
model
and then we're gonna Define a feature
extractor so our feature extractor now
is going to be
the feature extractor we've just defined
here
so let's go up and there we go so we
just we're gonna get this feature
extractor right here and then what we do
is we put it in here
so let's take all this off
we have all this off
that is now our future extractor so
we've gotten this feature extractor
that's it and then we also get X we're
gonna pass this true or feature
extractor there we go
stick all this off
and we'll find
now we're done with the future
extraction we can get the other pads
which make up the model like this
flattened the dance and the back Norm so
let's take this here
there we go
we are in this model and let's just copy
it let's paste it out here so here we're
gonna have this
also note that we're gonna have feature
or let's say Lunette this is all the net
model
modify this year we have the net model
the net model so that's fine now we've
gotten this everything is understood we
now check out this cell the flatten
equal flatten
and then next we have self.dance1
equal let's copy this out from here
simply so we have this dance right here
which is all Dance one
there we go
we have all dance
and then we have self.batch one
we just saw a batch normalization
there we go
copy this and paste
we move to Dance 2 and batch two so here
we have dance two we have batch two
um this is 10 actually so we have that
and then finally we have this dance
layer so let's take this off we have the
dance layer
I'll put one
activation sigmoid so that's it oh we
call this dance three
so that's fine everything seems okay
let's take this off now and then there
we go we get into our call method so
yeah we get into this call method and
this call method will basically call all
this different layers so after the
feature extraction notice how we've
created this class and this class makes
use of this feature extractor which was
also created using the same model as a
placing method so there we go we're
using this here
and we're actually using it here so
that's it
um now we just make this calls so we
have x equal sell the flatten
and then we pass x x equal
self.dance one
As an X
um
x equals self dot batch one
as an f and then finally we have this
so there we go we now return X just as
we did previously and we have our model
so here we have our learn net
net model the net
subclass
model and we have this the net here
lunet model
so let's take this off and there we go
we've just built our model
which when we try to find a summary so
we try to do the net subclass.summary
what do we obtain
you see we this model has not yet been
built build the model first by calling
build or by calling the model on a batch
of theater so we're going to call this
model on a batch of theater
right yeah we're gonna have the net
subclass and then we have tf.0 so you
have the zeros and one two two four two
two four
and three so let's run this and see what
we get
that's fine so here we have our summary
and then we are ready to compile this
model
um yeah we have the net
brunette subclass so we compiling a
surplus and then we're gonna fit the net
subclass the net
subclass so we feed that and everything
should work fine let's take this to just
five ebooks
you can see that we're getting similar
results when we compare this with what
we have with the functional API and the
sequential API so we now move on to
creating custom layers
if you could recall from the previous
sections the way the dense layer is
built is such that if we have this as
our dance layer and then we have this
input right here it's called this I oh
this is X we have this input X then we
have a certain
M times x
plus c
so this m is actually the weights so the
weights times x
plus the bias B let's call this B
and then this is now
equal our output so here we have an
output of y y equals MX plus C so the
simple means
if we want to recreate the dense layer
then we have to take this into
constellation or the definition of the
layer from scratch into consideration
that said we could Define a neural learn
dense so it's like our custom dense
neural and dense
um it's gonna
inherit from layer and then right here
this class so we have this class in
Harris home layer then from here we have
a neat method
neat
and then we have
the super we pass and learn dance there
we go we have that that meets
so that's it
um now from here if you have noticed
whenever we're creating a dance layer
like let's come up here whenever we're
creating the dance there we generally
had to specify at least because this is
by default this is uh not bad default
but
so here we need to pass in this year to
specify the number of output units now
that's set we have Declan the
consideration when building our neural
and dance layer so here we have output
units there we go we have our output
units and then here we'll Define
self.output units to equal output units
so that's it now from this point we're
gonna build this layer in order to build
this layer we have to take into
consideration this definition right
there
but this definition put out where this
isn't very clear
now let's make this all let's break this
up so you suppose now we have this input
of ship batch size by
let's see number of features so suppose
we have this input now what happens here
is
this input is going to be multiplied by
this weight so it's going to multiply by
this weight which happens to be a matrix
now we take this and multiply by that
Matrix
and for the multiplication to be valid
we need to ensure that the number of
columns we have here matches with the
number of rows of this Matrix but then
what are the dimensions of this Matrix
we have to note that this Matrix has to
be defined such that we have a shape of
f
this F here must match
by the number of output units so if you
want your number of output units for
example to be one then here you should
have one and that's why when defining
the dense layer we don't need to specify
this as this
value has gotten automatically from the
number of columns in the inputs since if
we don't take this we are going to have
an error so
um tensorflow test takes this
automatically fits in here and then
collects the input you passed in the
dense so when you specify when you say
you have this dance like this
now say for example one and maybe some
activation then you have that so let's
say we have some activation here now
once this one gets here this weight
Matrix is now defined sorry that the
input you pass into this dance is going
to affect the number of uh rows we have
but then what you pass in as argument
here is going to tell us give us a
number of columns we're going to have
for this weight Matrix right here so
that's that we have
um f by one and then when we multiply
this we're gonna have B by one so we see
we Now understand how we get this output
and then we have plus b by one
so that's it
where this one comes from the bias
now once we um add this up we have an
output of B by one and that's our y
That's the shape of our y
if that's understood we'll move on to
building so here we have our build
method we have cell and for now let's
keep it that way so there we go we have
this build method and then we're gonna
Define our weights so we have
self.weights
um let's specify weights we call that
and then here we're gonna have
the self dot add weight method so this
actually comes
with this layer class right here so
we're able to call this because we are
inheriting from the layer class so here
we have cell dot add weight and now we
specify the shape so guess what we are
going to have
um
our number of rows so n rows which is
going to come from the inputs and then
we're going to have a number of columns
which is going to come from this output
units you've specified we should pass in
when calling the neural land dense
um layer so here we're gonna have cell
dot output units so we get the number of
output units now how do we obtain this
number of input units we're going to
look at that shortly for now we have the
weights and then we have that and then
let's go to bias so we have self.iasis
and so the this is this is a weight add
weights
um and then yeah we specify
just the number of output units since
it's one dimensional so we have output
units
there we go
and so at this point we'll
um Define our weights and our bias
metrics recycled weight
just singular so that's it now let's go
into Carl so we have our call method
we should actually get a job done and
then we have our input so let's let's
call this uh yeah input
let's add an S obviously input data uh
input features so there we go so we have
that and then what we're gonna do here
is we're gonna return simply
the matrix multiplication as we've seen
already of the weights so we have self
dot weights and this input features
because it's actually the the input
features came so the weeks right let's
get back to this here if we take the
input yeah and it takes input times the
weights because if we have the weights
times the input we will have F1 times BF
we call our weights this I will cheat
and then this our input sheet I'll plan
this you see that this isn't always the
same so it's not going to be we're going
to try an error and so that's set what
we're gonna do is we're gonna just
we have input features right here
so that's it and then we add up the bias
so here we have self dot biases which
push it from this one right here now the
way we're gonna get this number of rows
is going to be easy
yeah all we need to do is to specify
here that we have the input
feature
features shoot we have our input
features shape which is going to come
automatically from this and then to get
the number of rows what we need to do
here is have input features
shape and then
we get that last Dimension so let's get
back to this because here we're having B
by f plus e
f
and so here we need the the weights it
needs to be f
by the output okay so to get this F we
just need to take the input and then get
this last element right here and this is
the number
of columns we have here so that set we
will just have that input features uh
specify this take this index and uh that
would be good so that's how we get we
obtain this value automatically the
number of rows we can
um looking for so now we've gotten this
everything seems fine next thing to do
is specify that it's trainable so we
have to specify that this weights are
trainable because in some cases we want
that the witch shouldn't be trainable so
set up the trainable equal
true now this must help you this is an
argument like isn't uh it's one of the
arguments which I've been passed into
this add weight method right here so we
just have that and then here again we
have this trainable
equal to
now apart from that we could randomly
initialize our
weights and biases so here we have
random normal
I'm not normal initialization
it's fine
and then we do senior so we have our
initializer
equals random normal
that's good
we now run this here's our neural learn
dance layer and then after running this
let's
get to integrate this let's make it
quite simple we just use our sequential
API so let's get back to the sequential
API we have built initially
do that and then we are going to
integrate this new dance layer this
neural learn custom dance layer
so there you go we have that and then
instead of dance there yeah we have
neural learn custom dance layer so you
see that you you can be able to create
your own layers with tensorflow
so that's it uh neural learn so neural
and dance neural and dance now you see
digital an error because we don't take
into consideration activation
and so what we could do is we could get
back right here and see
if the activation
is equal relu so if activation is equal
to low we'll return this and then
house
let's see I'll leave
activation is equal sign
return that oops
um let's get back
we have this so we're gonna return this
let's copy this and then paste out right
here and then we have else we've seen so
now let's get into this and the
modifications we're gonna make
um there we go so here we have our relu
in case it's relu for one and a half
years
TF Dot N N Dot relu of that so we're
gonna pass this in to our relu and then
if the activation is sigmoid
we should have to have the matte dot
sigmoid so that's it
there we go we have that and then this
one we just maintain so we've modified
our code such that we now integrate the
activations
there we go
that seems fine so let's run this and
then
um take this error
so here we have this double equals
python syntax and then we come down here
we can see it seems fine
um let's do this again uh yeah we're
supposed to have we're supposed to
specify Activation so we also have
activation and then
cell dot activation default activation
and then here we have cell dot
activation
solve that activation run that again
it's fine and then now what we do is we
pass we just simply run this so run that
and
we get in this error right here
to solve this problem what we're gonna
do is we're gonna include this shape
here so we're gonna have ship called
that and then ship equal this let's
rerun that and we should have no error
again oh yeah we haven't can set the
attributes weights likely because it
conflicts with an existing read only
property of the object so right here
instead of using weights we're just
going to say w
so we have the Wu and then
um right yeah we should have W now since
we don't want to repeat this over what
would you say here we have a pre output
so we have our print output which is
this
here
and is that out and then here we have w
right here we have B
that's it
and now we have if this then we pass the
pre output and we'll do the same right
here
so we have just a pre output before the
activation
now here we just have to print output
actually so we just have three output
take that off
um now running this should be fine so
let's run that and see what we get we
run this we run that and there we go we
have our model the same exact model we
have been building right from the start
but the stem around we're having are we
using a custom dense layer which is our
neural learn dance layer now let's go
ahead and compile this model and then
trim it
you have
um actually maintained this year so we
have to change this name
um here's the net model let's see the
net custom
uh yeah custom yeah custom custom model
yeah
okay we copied that
we have all the net custom model
right here
there we go we run it
that's fine
right yeah we have the net custom we run
that
here we have the net custom we run that
and then let's check out
as you can see with the train there's a
slight difference in the
last values and accuracy we're getting
for this first Epoch and most probably
this is coming from this random
um normal initialization with choosing
your as with the
standard dense layer which you could see
here this kernel initialization
or the weight initialization is using
this bluro uniform and the bias
initialization is the zeros so here we
have all zeros for the biases and then
here we use the glory uniform metal so
yeah as you could see this isn't
performing as well as what we had
previously but scrolling up there is
this error so here was meant to be
sigmoid so let's
um
stop this let's interrupt this training
and then get back and run this so we
will run this and compile and then start
with the training again
this time around it looks better it
looks more like what we should expect
so even though we're not using the
glorial initialization method this
training process looks quite similar to
what we would have had in the case of
the little initialization method which
is used with a standard dense layer and
here is what we get after training for
over five ebooks thank you for getting
up to this point and see you next time
hello everyone and welcome to this new
section in which we'll look at other
methods of evaluating our model other
than the binary accuracy which we've
been seen so far so in this section
we'll look at how to compute the true
positives false positives true negatives
false negatives the Precision the recall
the area under the curve how to come up
with conversion metrics like this and
finally how to plot out an Roc curve
like this one which permits us select
the threshold more efficiently don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification button so you never miss
amazing content like this
let's now look at other ways of
evaluating our model other than the
accuracy which we've seen so far
to better understand why working with
all of the accuracy isn't always a great
idea we have to take into consideration
the fact that
our model on a test set has
94 accuracy
now this means that we have
six out of a hundred
predictions which are actually false
now what if I get to the hospital and
I'm told that I don't have malaria when
in fact I actually have this disease
so that said the model predicts
uninfected and I actually have the
parasite in my bloodstream
now this particular situation becomes
very dangerous because the patient gets
back home thinking he or she doesn't
need any treatment whereas that patient
actually has this parasite you see that
even with a 94 percent accuracy we
wouldn't be able to save ourselves from
such chaotic model predictions
now in another example you have a
situation where the actual is let's put
it out here so in another example we can
have a situation where the actual is
unparasitized so actually you do not
have this parasite but the model
predicts that you have the parasite now
in this case
although we have a wrong prediction
we have actually a less chaotic
situation as compared to this previous
case here since
at least actually you are uninfected
if we consider negative
that's this negative to be
uninfected
and positive to be parts to contain the
parasite that's P so here we consider we
have positive and then we have negative
so here we have negative uninfected and
positive parasitized now if we let this
you will find that this first situation
where actually we have the parasite and
the model predicts unparasitized is
known as
a false
negative so here we have this false
negative
and this is because the model predicts
negative when it's it isn't actually
negative so since we have uh this round
prediction for negative we call it a
false negative and in this case where we
have the model prediction uh parasitized
that is positive when it's actually
negative we call this a false positive
so here we have f p
and here we have f n now there are two
other scenarios that is with TN
and TP for the TN we have the true
negative the true negatives and the TP
the true positives for the TN we have
the model
predicting negative when actually we are
negative that is we have the model
saying this is uninfected when actually
it's uninfected so that's a true
negative and then for the true positive
the model predicts a positive that's
parasitized when actually is parasitized
so that's a true positive
now hopefully you've understood the
concepts of true negatives true
positives false negatives and false
positives
we could then summarize all this
information in this Matrix known as the
confusion Matrix this conversion Matrix
we have the true negatives the number of
true negatives here the number of true
positives the number of false negatives
and the number of false positives
this means that if we have a test set of
say 2750
different data points and then we run
this or we evaluate this with our model
we'll be able to get this number of true
negatives get this number of false
negatives number of true positives
number of false positives and hence
better evaluate this model
so if we take this example where we've
evaluated our model on the test set and
then this model A produces this
confusion Matrix and this model B
produces other conversion Matrix where
here we see we have for the true
negatives and true positives we have a
thousand a thousand that's two thousand
correctly predicted
um data points and then here we have a
thousand a thousand two thousand
correlated points and then for this
model A we have
700 false positives
and 50 false negatives
whereas for model B we have 50 false
positives and 700 false negatives
recall we had defined negative to be
uninfected and positive to be
parasitized
and hence if we are to choose a model
between A and B we'll try to choose that
model which minimizes the number of
false negatives
so uh we are not saying that we
shouldn't minimize the number of false
positives because we have to try to
minimize
um all the false predictions but then
since with the false negatives
we are telling a sick person that he or
she isn't sick
this at least is worse than Talent uh a
healthy person that he or she is sick
and so we'll try to prioritize the
number of false negatives and based on
this prioritization we are going to
prefer Model A since we have the smaller
number of false negatives
and so here we'll choose Model A over
model B
now as a quick note you may decide to
say no negative is for parasitize and
pass series for uninfected it's not it
isn't
a must that this must be tied together
like this but for clarity purposes it's
better to look at it this way since
saying you are tested negative means
you're uninfected and tested positive
means you're parasitized
now you should also note that depending
on the kind of problem you want to solve
in some cases you will want to
prioritize minimizing the number of
false positive over the number of false
negatives so this actually depends on
the problem you're trying to solve
but in this case we are prioritizing the
number of false negatives
now based on what we've seen so far
we're going to introduce several new
performance metrics and all this
take up these different formulas we
could see right here we have the
Precision which is the not the number of
true positives divided by the number of
true positives plus the number of false
positives recall positives divided by a
number of true positives plus number of
false negatives the accuracy the number
of troops negatives plus number of true
positives divided by a number of true
negatives plus true positives plus false
negatives plus four positives so we'll
stop for in this first three for now
now what do you notice you'll notice
that in this position and recall we have
this true positive true positive and
yeah true positive true positive what
differentiates them is the fact that in
the position we have false positive in
the denominator and in the recall we
have false negative in the denominator
this means that if the number of false
negatives is high
that is if you have uh let's say we have
a constant a constant k
divided by a high value so constant
divided by high here we're going to have
a low output and so
if we want to have a low recall then we
need to have a high number of false
negatives and if we want to have a low
position then we need to have a high
number of false positives now in our
case we're trying to minimize the number
of
false negatives and since we're trying
to minimize the number of false
negatives it means that we're trying to
maximize the recall
since minimizing this denominator will
until maximizing this overall TP on TP
plus FN
and so here we're trying to prioritize a
recall over the Precision
now if you look at the accuracy you'll
notice that we have TN plus TP and TN
plus TP right here TN plus TP 10 plus TP
and we have FN plus FB if you are Keen
enough you should see that this accuracy
doesn't give any priority
for whether the false negatives are the
false positives it treats this two as
the same but as we've seen previously in
the real world in solving real world
problems many times would have to
prioritize hence the accuracy may not
always be the best metrics for a problem
in our case we find that using the
recall
is even better than using the accuracy
as with the recall
we get to reduce or with the recall we
get to see whether our model
does well at minimizing the number of
false negatives
now we also have this F1 score two times
the Precision times recall this position
just recall divided by the position plus
recall the specificity the number of
true negatives divided by number of two
negatives plus number of false positives
and then we also have this Roc plot
right here Roc stands for receiver
operating characteristics here we have
the true positive rate and the false
positive rate the true positive rate is
the number of true positive a number of
true passive plus number of false
negatives which happens to be the recall
and then the false positive rate is the
number of false positives divided by
number of false positives plus the
number of true negatives
which if you look carefully you'll find
that is equal 1 minus the specificity
which has been defined right here
before getting to understand this Roc
plot which we've put out here
let's
recall this two models which we have
described previously that's Model A and
model B where Model A had a smaller
number of false negatives as compared to
model B
now if we pick out Justice Model A and
then we are interested in reducing this
or let's say we pick our model B suppose
we pick up model B are we interested in
reducing this number of false negatives
right here
then one solution could be that of
modifying the threshold so if we have a
threshold of 0.5 meaning that
above like we have the 0.5 below 0.5 we
consider negative above 0.5 we consider
positive that is parasitized and then
below uninfected
then what I could do here is reduce this
threshold so if I take this threshold to
set a value of 0.2 let's take this year
so I've reduces threshold now to 0.2
you'll see that
for most of the predictions our model is
going to say that this is a parasitized
output since now this threshold has been
reduced this means that if we have a
model prediction of 0.3 which initially
would have been
uninfected now this model
sees this as parasitized
and so this makes it now more difficult
for a model to have false negatives
since our model now has
this tendency of predicting that are
given an input image is parasitized
that said we now look we now need to
look for a way that we could automate
this process that is we want to
be able to choose this threshold
correctly or rightly because if let's
say we take a threshold of
um say
0.001 it means that anytime our model
predicts less than 0.01 it's unparated
uninfected and then greater than 0.01 is
parasitized
then this will be very dangerous for the
overall model performance as now most
times would have the model predicting
that the input is parasitized
and so our Emir is to pick this
threshold such that
this number of true positives and true
negatives we've had right here don't get
reduced
now the way we could look at this is now
by using this Roc plot with this Roc
plot what you actually have here is the
different
through passive rates and false positive
rates you would have at a given
threshold so this means that a point
picture is just a given threshold now
let's suppose that the threshold um 0.5
is about year so let's pick this let's
suppose that this is 0.5 we could pick
another threshold let's say this one is
say 0.2 and so on and so forth let's say
this one is 0.1
now we could have another model with
this different Roc plot another one with
this kind of Roc plot but note that
overall our aim is to ensure that this
false positive rates is minimized and
the true positive rate is maximized so
if we have an RC plot which is like this
so let's let's re draw this if we have
this kind of Roc plot that is one that
goes up straight like this and then
comes this way we have this
right here so if we have this kind of RC
plot then
we will be able to pick out this
threshold right here zero point
um say x I'll be able to pick this
threshold
because at this threshold for this
Threshold at this point the true passive
rate is at its highest value that is of
one and then the false positive rate
that's as low as possible value that is
of zero so here we have one and then
zero so the here we go we have this and
then we pick out this threshold now this
value of x could be five it could be
four or whatever so we have zero point
whatever value will lead us to this
nonetheless many times we wouldn't have
this kind of plots so uh we will do it
plus which will look like this
uh this and so on so forth now once
given a plot like this one let's suppose
we have a plot like this one the M years
to ask yourself the right question
if I want to make sure that my recall is
always maximized which is our case we'll
try to ensure that we pick out this
points around this so we'll try to pick
out these points uh towards the top
right here let's take some of this off
so as we're saying
um if you want to maximize our recall
it's about normal that will pick out
threshold values which will take us
around this region because it's around
this region that our recall is maximize
let's do this so you could see that
clear
okay now the problem with picking a
point around this is that when you pick
a point around this the false positive
rate is increased so you need to find
that balance between this false positive
rate and true positive rate so it will
be much logical to pick a point around
this right here so we could pick around
this region instead
of this previous region right here now
you can see that in this region all
right let's say we pick this point if
you pick this point your false positive
rate now is smaller while your true
passive rate is or your recall is
maximized though it isn't the best
possible recoil we could have but trying
to focus on getting that recoil of one
will lead you into trouble since getting
a recall of one in this case will
increase our false positive rate
and then if we're dealing with a problem
where we're trying to maximize the
position then in that case we want to
ensure that this false positive rate is
minimized and so in this kind of
problems we want to pick a point around
this so you see we want to pick this
kind of value since at least all false
positive radius
minimized but then if you want to go and
pick a point around this year you would
have a false positive rate of zero but
doing this will take get you this into
trouble because yeah you're gonna have a
true passive rate which is very small
and so you need to get that balance
now if you're having a problem where
it doesn't really matter that is you
aren't trying to prioritize the position
or to recall and working with the
accuracy is just fine then you could
pick out this point right here so this
is when you are having or you don't have
to prioritize on any here is when you're
trying to prioritize on the recall and
yours when you're trying to prioritize
on the Precision
but at least one great tennis with this
tool that is the ROC plot we are able to
pick out this point and then
automatically get that threshold we need
to work with
and so when doing predictions we will
not or we may not use 0.5 but we're
gonna use a certain threshold which will
suit those objectives we've set
initially now we'll now move to the area
under the curve for the area under the
curve we generally use this when we
comparing two models
here we have this model let's call it
Model A it's not it's not it's not
actually this model a it's a different
Model E let's call this model Alpha and
then we have this other model which we
shall call model better so we have model
Alpha and model beta
it's clear that model beater is better
because it gives us better options
now you'll see that
if I find myself here
I get it better
through positive rate false positive
read balance as compared to when I find
myself at this position
and so if we are comparing these two
models we could make use of the area
under the curve by calculating this area
covered here so let's bound this and
then for Alpha we have this a Ariana
curve popularly known as AUC a small U
and then C
which will give us this and then for
beater we're gonna have this area under
the curve now which covers this area
plus this extra area right here and so
in general if we have two models and
then we want to compare them then we
could use this area under the curve
since it shows us how much Freedom we
have in playing around with this
thresholds we now get back to the code
and see how we're going to implement
this new metrics we've just talked about
so right here we have metrics and then
we have the false positives we have the
false negatives we have the true
positives we have the true negatives we
have the Precision
we have the recall we have the AUC AUC
and then since we're done with a binary
classification problem here we have
binary accuracy we run that that's fine
and then right here instead of having
those metrics we'll Define this Matrix
list which will contain these different
metrics which we've just talked of so we
have the true positive false positive
right up to the AUC let's run this
compile and then feed our model you'll
see that as we train we have the true
positives false positives through
negatives false negatives accuracy
precision recall and AUC scores which
have been given to us as you could see
here are the results we obtained we're
gonna go ahead to evaluate our model
so let's get to the model evaluation we
run this test data and then we have our
model evaluated
there we go our model has been evaluated
as you could see we have this last
0.35 number of true positives uh
1323 number of false positives uh number
of true negatives false negatives
accuracy precision recall and AUC so
that's what we have for this model
for now we have been showing you this
binary accuracy false positives up to
AUC what if we plot out the coefficient
Matrix and also the ROC plot so we'll
import scikit learn and Seaborn right
here we have
scikit-learn and from scikit learn dot
metrics we're going to import confusion
metrics
and then
um for c bond we need to impart C barn
and S SNS so that's it so here we are
important so I can learn and seeborn
which will both use in
plotting out this coefficient Matrix so
let's run this and then we'll visualize
our conversion Matrix
so we'll have to get the level
that's the True Values of the outputs
and then we'll also get the predicted
values so here we want to get the levels
and the predicted values now let's start
with the levels so here we're going to
have levels we have this list
um there we go and then for
X Y oh let's say for here for X Y in
the test data set
we're gonna
take this as numpy iterator so for x y
and this we have the X and the Y we have
that
and then we
append every output to these levels so
here we have levels dot append Y and we
run that so that's fine we could now
print out levels what do we get
there we go you see we have those levels
now let's convert it into
a simpler form where we just have only
this values in here and not this arrays
which we have here so in order to get
that we have levels will be equal levels
all right that would be equal
array and here we're going to create
this list so in this list here
for every element of this levels list so
for
um here for I in levels
we're gonna do I
the zeroth
index so we're gonna take always this
element right here so that's it we have
that and now we have levels let's print
out the levels after doing this
transformation
there we go here's our levels now so we
have that fine go take that off
we have this error actually because we
tried
um we've converted these levels already
and then we're trying to reconvert them
so let's comment this right here we
comment that and run this and we have
all levels okay now we have those levels
we could move ahead and get the
predicted values so to get this
predicted values we have our Lunette
model Lunette
learn net model there we go dot predict
what we're gonna pass in this predict
method is our input so we have the input
and then right here we add this input
list and then we do same as we deal with
the levels so we have input that append
X which is this input here now we will
run this and then let's add a cell so we
add this code cell and then we're going
to pre-process our input so from this
we're just going to print out the input
to see what it gives us or what kind of
shape we're having right here let's put
numpy array
while that's loading shape then we run
this other cell right here
here's what we get as shape so we have
to take this off this one off here and
to do that you see we would have
the input will select this first index
so we take that and then for this next
we take only one so we're gonna chop
this off and then we have the rest so
that's it now uh we run this again
and we should have put a shape here so
we run that again
and there we go so this is what we
expect now we've gotten the levels and
then
we are now ready to get the predictions
so here we have this input
oh take this and then we pass it in here
we pass our input and we get our
predictions let's print out the
predicted here
oh yeah let's put another predicted and
see what we get so what we get right
here we could print out a shape
to better understand what this is and as
you could see we have this so how do we
take this over how do we make it look
like the levels
um we could simply
take this off so we have we select the
first and then for this one we take it
off so we run that again
and there we go so now we could do this
take out the shape and then it should
look like the levels we've had here
and that's it so now we've gotten this
our next step is to use uh the confusion
metrics from cycle and metrics and
produce our conversion Matrix now let's
comment this sections first so here
we've passed in the labels with pass in
the predicted and then we'll specifying
this threshold so what we're saying here
is
all values greater than the threshold
considered uninfected and all values
less than or equal to threshold is going
to be considered as containing the
parasite and then we're going to have
this in this confusion Matrix here so we
run that
and then as you could see we have our
coefficient Matrix which shows us the
number of true positives true negatives
false positives and false negatives
getting back to our model evaluation
we'll see exactly which of those values
are the True policies false positives
true negatives or false negatives so
let's just copy this out here we take
this up and we shall see that below so
here we have this confusion Matrix which
we've just seen here is it right here
conversion metrics right here
and then let's place this out here so we
have the number of true positives
um this one matches and then number of
true negatives one two nine eight yeah
this is closer so what cycle learn gives
us is quite similar to what we had with
tensorflow but they're not exactly the
same so this tells us that this is the
number of true negatives this is the
number of no this is a number of true
negatives right here so here we have two
negatives here we have true positives
then here we have false positives and
then here we have false negatives
we'll then see how modifying this
threshold will either reduce the false
negatives or reduce the false positives
so let's have say 0.25 right here we run
that again
and there we go
um let's print this so we see that we
now have a number of false negative
reduced when we reduce the threshold
we now go back and then take this to
0.75 we run that again
you see that this is now reduced so here
we have a review uh an increased number
of false negatives and a reduced number
of false positives when the threshold is
increased to 0.75
so that's it let's now
pin out all right let's now plot out
this
more elegantly looking figure with the c
bun Library so here we go we run that
and that's it so here we have uh same
conversion Matrix but
hmm
more elegantly plotted let's take back
to zero point five here
and have that okay so that's it
now you notice that or when we're trying
to say reduce more false negatives or
number of false positives what we're
doing is we're just picking up some
values here like we could pick up 0.2
and then we see its effect and we could
do the same for 0.25 you see how this
takes us to 58 and this to 130 we could
continue doing this
until we get our best results but then
this isn't very efficient
since we're just trying out different
values now the way we could do this more
efficiently is by working with Roc plots
where we'll be able to choose a
threshold in a more efficient manner
using the plots and so we'll be able to
reduce the number of false negatives or
number of false positives without having
to try out all these threshold values
manually
the very first thing we'll start with
will be to import RC curve so we have RC
curve and this is part of psychic learn
metrics so we'll run this again
and then just right here we'll make use
of our method uh we're gonna output the
number of oh it's going to Output a
number of false positives through
positives and then thresholds which
we're using coming up with the ROC plot
so we have that we have our OC curve
Roc curve and then this takes in the
levels and then the TR and then the
predicted so we have this predicted
value now if you pin this length out the
length of FB length of CP and land of
thresholds see we have exactly the same
number
thresholds here
we should have exactly the same number
here we have 330
330. okay so now we have this now note
that the reason why we need this is
because when coming up with our Roc plot
like say we have this Roc plot we want
to have for each and every point the
corresponding TP FP and then the
threshold which will lead to that
so that said we are going to make use of
this data now and then plot out the ROC
curve so let's get straight into that we
have our plot and then we do plotting we
pass in the false positives through
positives just like X Y so here we have
X and then here is y let's get back
that's fine and then from here we have
the levels so we have X level which is
a false positive
and then the Y level uh
true positive rate
so we've seen this already now we have
this we could include the grid so we
have this grid and then we show so
that's it
we run that
and here is what we get so this is our
RC plot right here based on this FP and
CP we got from here now how do we
include this thresholds in order to
include the thresholds we are going to
make use of mapler leaps test method so
we have plot the text and then here
we're gonna have the TP
or another FB TP and then what the the
actual text will be putting in here will
be the thresholds so we'll be passing in
the thresholds but now not that we
actually have to do this for each and
every point which isn't possible since
there will be too many uh texts put out
here and it's going to be choked up so
what we could do is we could skip some
values so we'll say for I
in range we're going to start from zero
right up to the length that's actually
going to be 330 length of thresholds and
then we're gonna be skipping some values
so skip and then we'll Define the skip
so let's start with this cube of 20 so
initially we're going to skip 20 values
and then once we skip this value let's
pass this in here I want to keep this
value with pick in a given I it cannot
give an i same here and then we do the
same with the thresholds
so we get the corresponding false
positive rate corresponding through
positive rate and then the corresponding
threshold now it has done uh we could
run this so
here is what we get we see this plot now
we could see the ROC plot with the
different thresholds
um let's I think we could
let it like this it's fine let's
increase the size
and then we'll try to focus just on this
portion which actually matters the most
because uh we wouldn't want to get into
this regions because in these regions
our false positive rate
it's going to be too high and this
region is below this would have a very
small true passive rate so generally
we'll try to focus on this zone right
here now depending on the problem you
are trying to solve if your false
positive rate is what matters the most
that is if you cannot afford to have a
high false positive rate then you would
tend to pick values let's say let's
let's break it out like this so here is
like the mid points we have some sort of
meat here let's let's draw this line
okay so we have some sort of midpoint
here so this like 0.5 0.46 0.62 and all
of that so we're breaking it up like
this and then if you want to ensure that
you try to minimize as much as possible
your false positive rate without
reducing your true positive rates too
much then you tend to take values around
this but if you want to make sure a true
positive rate
remains quite High even in the detriment
of the false positive rate then you
would tend to pick our values in the
zone so you have these two zones to pick
your threshold from this is the main
Zone and then you have this Zoom right
here this AutoZone and this other zone
so we have Zone one and zone two from
which you have to pick from
one other quick note is that if you have
a problem like the one we're trying to
solve where power side
is zero and then uninfected is one so
this is how the data set was created and
this based on this we build our model
then this means that this will be
considered as negative samples while
this will be considered as positive
samples whereas in the real world we'll
tend to look at uninfected as negative
and parasitic as positive so you have to
be very careful with this terms and know
exactly how your dealer and models have
been built
and that's why in our case where we're
trying to avoid situations where our
model predicts a fake uninfected output
that is a patient who actually has a
parasite but the model predicts that's
uninfected there's actually a fake
uninfected this is a fake
of false positive in our case so we'll
tend to minimize this
number of false positives now if your
mother was built such that parasitic is
one and then uninfected is zeros then
it's clear that you try to instead
minimize the number of false negatives
since uninfected is considered as
negative
that said coming back to our problem
since our data set was constructed in
this way
we're trying to minimize the number of
false positives at all cost but while
doing this we have to ensure that the
true passive rate remains at the
reasonable position
and so we could pick out a threshold of
like
0.6265 given right here
getting back to this let's take
0.6265 we run that we have here a number
of false positives to be 87 which is
going to be smaller than when we're
having a threshold of say 0.5
run that again you see 87 is going to be
smaller than this 99 the value of 99
we're getting now
and so that's it for this section on
metrics thank you for following up up to
this point and see you next time
what's up everyone and welcome to this
new section in which we'll build
callbacks with tensorflow in the section
we'll look at how to build a callback
from scratch by inheriting from the
Callback class and then we'll build
other callbacks made available by
tensorflow like the CSV logger L is
topping learning rate scheduler model
checkpointing and finally reduce
learning rate on Plateau callback don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification button so you never miss
amazing content like this
callbacks are methods we call during
training evaluating our prediction
this callbacks can permit us extract
useful information from those processes
we just listed or even carry out changes
on this processes you're in this
tensorflow documentation we have TF
Keras and then we have the callbacks so
this is what we have for the
documentation we could go through each
and every one of this but for the sake
of this course
we are going to look at the key ones so
right here we have this callback but
before we get into this we are going to
look at the history the reason why we're
looking at history first actually
because we've used it already so we use
this callback Without Really knowing
that we're using call Max
so yeah we're told this is a callback
that records event into a history object
so remember the times we were having
this year so
um after training that's when when we're
training we start some information in
the history and then after training
we're able to come up with plus like
this because we have this information
start in this history right here so that
said as you could see
in this example which is kind of like
similar to what we've been seeing so far
we have this history and it collects all
values we've been starving during
training and then we could print out
those params history.params we get the
params and then we could also get the
keys
so that's how this works we've seen this
already and then we could look at this
callback
class right here now the reason why this
is like the most important of all this
different callback classes is because
this is kind of like the mother
class all that abstract based class
which can be used and building new
callbacks so if you want to build a
callback which isn't least a year you
could always get back to this and then
build that callback from scratch so here
we have this
callback class which has attributes as
you could see Power arms and model and
then it also has this methods which will
see how to implement very easily if you
look at this on batch begin in this
unbatch and you'll see that the take
similar arguments like here we have the
batch and then we have those logs then
for the next the ebook begin and the
ebook and they're actually taking the
ebook and the locks
that set will impart the Callback so
here we have from tensorflow Keras
callbacks we're gonna import callback
this class which we're going to be using
and creating our callbacks we run that
then we Define this call by class which
will note as called last callback we
have this last callback class which
inherits from the Callback which we've
just imported and then we will make use
of the different methods which you
haven't given to us in the documentation
let's start with the on Epoch end so on
input and we're taking the ebook and
then uh what we're gonna do is we're
gonna pin out the loss values at the end
of an ebook so what we'll be doing is
kind of similar to what we have already
here so let's do that and have print
Epoch number
let's say ebook number this
and then has a loss
of for
ebook number this our method the model
has a loss
of this and then we just format so there
we go we pass in the epoch let's have
this here and the locks so just as in
the documentation where we're at in the
ebook and the locks now uh we are going
to pass in the epoch and then the locks
but since we want to get just the last
we could get the loss from this so we
have this dictionary here and we pick
out just the last now
let's run this and then we'll see how to
include a callback in the training
process so just right here we're gonna
have callbacks so the callbacks argument
and we have this list so in this list
we're going to insert this callback
we've just created here so we have the
last callback we should just passed in
here and that's fine so now let's rerun
this let's take this for say three
ebooks and then see what we get
we get in this error we click search
stack Overflow and then click on this
you'll see that we have a solution just
here and what it said here is why you're
gonna pass is the object and not the
class itself so that said instead of
passing the last callback as we just did
we're gonna pass in this object so we're
gonna put in the brackets let's
uh modify those points here
and passing a space so we're gonna have
that uh to next line
and then we will run that again so let's
run that and that's fine then after
training for over three epochs here's
what we get we see that on like before
where we just have this I'll put it now
we have this
message Opera that is for Epoch number
zero the model has a lot of this for
epic number one and then for April
number two now what we could do is we
could add this so we have this formatted
normally so we don't start from zero but
anything from one so we could say plus
one right here so that's it now another
thing we could do is we could have on
batch end so on batch and we have that
and then we have the batch we pass in
the locks this time around what we want
to do is kind of similar to what we've
seen already here so we just spin this
out that's fine take that off so for the
batch number
for this batch number the model has a
loss of this so there we take in the
batch so that's it and then we log out
the loss now yeah let's just pick up
this locks totally so we have the locks
and then that's fine so yeah we've put
in the batch unlike it will pass in the
ebooks we run this again
and run this run this
you'll notice that this time around we
have much more information which has
been locked out let's take this here and
get right to the top what we have here
is for batch number one the model has
this loss so you see that this is after
each and every batch so here the first
batch we have this log and then the next
batch we have this lock and so on and so
forth
and since our batch size equal 32 the
simple means after working on
32 different data points we're gonna
have this locked out and then the next
32 we have this locked out right up to
the end
now for the ebooks you'll notice that as
we go on so we're moving on to let's get
right up to 689.
oh we have that and
final year we have 689 okay so for this
last year last at the end of the ebook
we now have this locked out so here we
have for Epoch whereas previously we had
for batch for for all the different
batches
in case you want to understand how we
got this 689 right here you could take
the total data set site and then divide
by the current by size which is 32 you
should get this 689 which is given right
here
so from this we could look at the CSV
logger now with the CSV logo what we're
actually doing is we're logging out this
information in a CSV file or in some
file which we're going to Define
so what we'll do is just simply copy
this now this time around we wouldn't
actually have to uh we create a class as
we just did with the callbacks because
this kind of like
a general way of creating these
callbacks now with the CSV logger we'll
actually create the Callback more easily
so here we have this
and then we're going to specify the file
name so yeah let's have the CSV callback
you call that let's take this off and we
specify our file name so yeah we just
have a file locks.csv
and that should be fine so we take that
off
take that off and then
up right here we have to import CSV
logger
that's fine we run that
thing is okay uh we get back to our
callback and then
we run this cell right here now note
that this append is as described in the
documentation
a Boolean which tells us whether the
locks we are currently putting in the
CSV file or in the file in general
are gonna be appended on previously
locked content or not so when we have
this as false we suppose in that this is
empty and so we are going to like be
putting information on this file for the
very first time so we'll run this and
then now all we need to do to take this
new callback into consideration is to
have your CSV call back so let's uh make
sure let's take this batch logs out from
here so we are not going to take this
last call back into consideration any
longer we run this
after three epochs we're gonna open this
up and then we have this Luxor CSV file
which has been created so let's have
that and as you could see we have this
CSV file which we could now download and
then view it later so here we have the
accuracy AUC and all the other metrics
and loss values which we want to store
so that's fine and next thing we could
do is we could get back again here and
then I'll select append true so if we've
done training the first time I want to
redo the training process we don't want
to erase all the values we had
previously so here we set this up and
true run this again
after three epochs we open this log.csv
file and what do you have here you see
we have this new information which is
just been appended on the previous
information
from this CSV logger we could now move
on to this early stopping callback right
here
to better understand Alice stop in let's
get back to the plots which we had
previously so let's take out this plot
of the model's accuracy where we see how
the train accuracy keeps increasing
while after a certain point let's say
this point here let's take this off
after say this point our models or even
this point here
our models validation accuracy doesn't
increase any further so uh what we have
in here is something like this we have
this training accuracy which increases
and goes towards one and then the
validation accuracy which is
something like this now in some other
cases you will even have situations
where this starts to drop nonetheless in
this case we have uh this plot where it
just kind of like stabilizes and doesn't
increase any further now note that this
kind of situation is known as
overfeeding
in our feeding the model starts
to overfeed the training data so because
the model has been trained on the
training data and not on the violation
dinner
at a certain points the model stops or
ceases to generalize because the aim of
this training process is not to come up
with a model
which only performs well on the training
theater we're trying to come up with a
model which performs well on any type of
data be it a train be it a validation or
the test data so if we're able to have a
model which does the same or which has
the same performance with the trend and
with a validation with the test then
that model is an ideal one but in this
case we see that as keep on training
the models parameters have been modified
to suit only the training data and this
is very dangerous because at a certain
point
you may feel like because you're having
high train accuracy your model is
performing well whereas this isn't the
case because when your model will be
shown new dealer like the validation in
this case and the test later on this
model wouldn't perform as well as it
will do as well as is doing with the
training data So to avoid this kind of
false
measurements we tend to stop the
training once this over feeding starts
to occur so this means that if you
training and then your validation let's
take let's suppose we're stopping at
this here so we're training and then
your validation
data or your validation accuracy seems
to be constant whereas that of the
training seems to kind of increase then
is better for you to stop training at
this point because after this point the
model parameters are just been modified
to suit the training data and doesn't
really generalize which is the case here
because we're trying to
extract some information from this data
and make the model intelligent so the
model doesn't become intelligent by only
modifying its weights or parameters
based on the data it's been trained upon
is intelligent because
after being trained it can
perform well on theater it has never
ever seen so here we have this L is
stopping where after we noticed that
this the validation accuracy doesn't
seem to increase any further which is
kind of like stop the training and then
use the model parameters from this
number of epochs so we could say that
after say 12 epochs we just stop the
training now let's take this off and
then do replicate something similar for
the loss
so if we're having a loss we could have
something like this and then that so
here we have the number of epochs and
then we have the loss so you could have
a situation where you're having you're
training data which uh you're training
loss which keeps increa or reducing
whereas for the validation you see you
would have them like this so this is a
typical
platform overfeeding nonetheless in our
case or the model over fees bet not that
much in some cases you have a situation
where this even starts to drop and uh
where the loss starts to increase after
a certain point here is a validation
loss and then here is a training loss
obviously the training last week always
keep reducing
because we are training on this training
data so uh what we're saying is at this
point where the validation stops
reducing it's important to just stop
this training and this is known as early
stopping now
recall that the aim of callbacks is to
be able to modify the training process
the evaluation process or the test
process that's a prediction process
in an automatic manner so that said
we shall make use of this early stopping
callback right here which will permit us
stop training automatically once we
notice that a given parameter like say
the last validation loss doesn't drop
any longer
so here we're just gonna copy this and
then we just
applied similarly to what we are done
with the CSV callback so yeah we add
this text and then we add that code we
just place this out
now we Define this es callback that's
early stopping callback and and then
we'll look at the significance of each
and every one of those arguments now
coming back to the documentation we have
this monitor quantity to be monitored so
uh by default here we have this vowel
loss this means that
this callback will simply check on this
validation loss right here and then once
it stops reducing like see at this point
we're gonna stop the training
whereas if we change this to say
validation Precision or validation
accuracy then what will be monitoring
will be that accuracy are the Precision
value so if you have them like this
we'll see we'll stop around this right
here to ensure that we don't go and
overfeed on the training dealer
the next argument is this mean Delta
argument right here so with the mean
Delta argument we are defining a minimum
change
below which any uh changes considered as
no improvement so if you're having a
loss like this
and that our mean Delta is say a value
of 0.1 then even if this loss reduces by
a value of 0.5 then this callback will
consider that there has been no decrease
in the loss because the mean Delta is
0.1 Now by default the mean Delta
assessed to zero this means that any
slight change is considered as a drop so
if we have even
0.0005 then we consider this as a a drop
in the loss
now this is important because this has a
patience those callbacks make use of
those patients
with those patients we are defining the
number of epochs
above which
if we don't have a decrease in the
validation loss like in this case of the
validation loss we consider that we
could stop that training process and for
the accuracy is the number of ebooks
above which if we don't have an increase
in the validation accuracy if we've
picked validation accuracy for the
monitor then would have to stop the
training so we Define this what we
predefined this so that this could run
automatically
now for the mode by default we have the
auto mode but we could specify mean on
Max notice that when speaking about the
loss we spoke of
um a value or
the number of epochs above which if the
loss doesn't decrease so here we're
supposing that the loss is meant to be
decreasing and in that case we are
having a mode of mean now for the
accuracy we spoke of uh for the
patient's number of epochs above which
if the accuracy doesn't increase so in
this case we're having the max now what
tensorflow permits also do is to use the
auto and what is auto tensorflow
automatically infers whether it's
dealing with a mean or Max
so this means that if you place in for
example valve position this Auto should
be able to understand that a position
should be increasing so it's going to
use a Max
then we move to the Baseline where the
training stops if the model doesn't show
improvement over the Baseline then
finally we have this restore best
weights with the restore best weights
which by default is false
we are simply saying that the model is
going to take up its final state so this
means that if we start
monitoring the models here at this point
here or at this point where we have the
lowest possible VAR loss and then the
model let's say we have a patients of
five so we we're gonna train for 45
epochs before stopping so if after five
ebooks we are on this let's suppose that
defeat Epoch we are on this so we've
added from here plus five ebooks we are
on this and then we are having this loss
it's clear that this model with this
loss is less performant than this one
now if this restart best way to set to
false then we just take the model's
widths here or the model weights which
give this loss value here whereas if
it's set to true then it means we're
gonna take the best weights we've had
throughout the training process and
which happens to be the weights which
provide this loss right here
that said here we go we have this we
have let's say the patience to three uh
where positive one oh mode Auto Baseline
known restore best way is false so let's
run that and then all we need to do
is to just include this year so here
we're gonna have ES
call back now we could take off the CSV
callback but you could always uh put all
this together let's just let it so we
could
see how all that works so we just have
this list right here and we have this es
callback with the CSV callback now we
run the training
we didn't train this for long enough to
be able to observe any
callback changes so let's take this to
10 epochs and then we reduce this to one
or two let's take this to two uh we'll
run that again
so that's fine and then we fit our model
after training for eight ebooks we see
clearly here how the earliest top in
callback stops the training process now
let's understand why this is all this
training process has been stopped if you
take take a look at this validation loss
right here you would find that there was
a drop here drop uh increase but after
this increase there was a drop and since
the
patience is equal to that's the patients
we had to find here equal to we have to
get two successive increases or two
successive
same loss values before the training
process could be stopped so since we
after this we have a drop the training
process continues then we have this
increase and then we have this drop so
it continues then here we have this
increase and then here again we have
this other increase so because now we
have had this two successive increases
as we could see in the plot right here
you see right here
where we have this increase drop
increase and then increase
we now have the training process which
is been stopped as you could see here
that said we will now move on to the
learning rate scheduling
up to this point we've been used to
train our models with one fixed learning
rate throughout the process so we could
fix our learning rate as we did to say
0.01 and we use this same learning rate
throughout our whole training process
but it happens that if this learning
rate is too large then we reached
diverging and if the learning rate is
too small
it would take too long for our model to
converge so let's consider this plot
right here is actually a very simplified
plot as actually uh what really happens
is way more complex than this so let's
consider this plot and we have this
and here we have the last Ricola m
and the weights so here we have loss and
then weights or parameters uh and our
aim is actually to modify this weights
such that the loss is minimized so our
aim is to get all to get to this
position right here
now without the case where we have a
high learning rate so if we're dealing
with a high learning rate then uh it
will be easier for our model to find its
way to this minimum position right here
or to some position close to this
minimum position let's say at this point
here
but the problem here is or once it gets
to this position it could also very
easily diverge for me to it would very
easily get back to another Point around
here and then repeat this kind of
process again where the model just kind
of diverges so you could have something
like this it could come down here and
then get back to some point around this
and so on and so forth so we may have
this case where the model doesn't really
converge because the learning rate is
too high and then for the small learning
rates
we may start training and then if say
the model or if we find ourselves at
this point here that is we've modified
the weights such that the loss value
happens to be at this point here it
becomes difficult for us to get to this
uh ultimate
or Global Minima
since the learning rate is too small and
the changes were making uh very small
changes so you may find ourselves just
oh staying around this local Minima here
instead of going towards This Global
Minima which is this
and so to bring in a balance what we
could do is when we start the training
process we could
use a relatively High Learning rate such
that the model kind of approaches This
Global Minima faster and then after a
certain number of epochs we start or we
modify the learning rate search that it
becomes or it takes in very small values
and since it now takes in small values
we now start taking up very small
changes such that we can get towards
This Global Minima now
without risking Divergence
now one way of doing this is by say you
could fix let's say you could suppose
that for the first 10 ebooks you train
your model
a learning rate of C 0.1 and then from
10 to 20 you're going to train a Model A
learner of say 0.01 let's say we're
dividing by a factor of 10 so we now
move to 0.01 and the next 10 again uh
let's say we're training all this for 30
epochs and then the next we go to
0.001 so you could train your model and
then after 10 epos you restart the
training by modifying the learning rate
in your Optimizer and then again you do
this same year but now the problem with
this is
you always have to be there to ensure
that after the training that's after the
10 epochs you modify this manually now
what if we're able to do this
automatically
as usual this is made possible by
tensorflow callbacks with this callback
that's the learning rate schedule a
callback we could Define a function
which takes in the number of epochs and
then modifies the learning rate based on
the current ebook
oh
based on a mixture of the current ebook
and some predefined function
so as you could see here we have the
learning rate scheduler it takes a meta
schedule and then we could specify the
verbosity
now this is an example of this scheduler
method which has been defined here yeah
what it do is if the number of ebooks is
less than 10 then you're gonna use this
predefined learning rate
and then
in the case where the number of inputs
is greater than equal 10 then we start
to
reduce this learning rate in an
exponential manner so there we go let's
take this off now what we're saying here
is we're modifying the learning rate
such that after that's we're having
before 10 ebooks we're having this fixed
learning rate
that's it and then after this we start
to reduce this so the learning area
starts dropping as we continue with the
training so now we don't really need to
be uh monitoring the training manually
because this callback will automatically
modify the learning rate for you
we could simply copy out this example
which has been given to us right here
and then make use of it in our training
process so here we have to include this
text and then our code so here we paste
out the scheduler let's let's delete
this and then for this one we have our
learning rate scheduling
callback so learning rate
scheduler and then we do this import so
yeah again we just have learning rate
scheduler we run that and then get back
to this position
um right here
let's do this one two three so that's
fine so notice that here we have this
order so we have the callbacks learning
with Shadow law
and we have CSV logger L is stopping
learner scheduler under the callbacks so
that's fine uh let's get back to that
and then we are gonna Define so here
we've had the letter or this Shadow
method but we're yet to Define our
language
schedule a callback so we have our our
let's say scheduler Shadow law call back
equals learning rate scheduler and then
it takes in this Shadowland method right
here so that's fine notice how the
shadow La method takes in the current
Epoch and the current Epoch number and
the learning rate so here we have this
uh given to us already and so we'll
modify this to take say for example
three so after three equals we're gonna
modify learning rates and then we could
print out uh the learning rate so we
could say for example the current
learning all actually what we could do
is let's take this off let's not have
that let's specify the variability
to be equal one so here we have the
variables is specified as one and then
um we'll take off this
so you could also check out the CSV
logger
the locked CSV file so you'll notice how
throughout we've been logging these
values since we're just doing we're just
adding up or stacking up the values on
the previous values we've had already so
for now what we could do is take this
off now let's take this off the all this
and then focus on just the scheduler so
we have scheduler callback and that's
fine
let's ensure that the cells have been
run already so that should be okay now
we have in this error verbosity uh
unexpected keyword arguments let's come
back get back to this here and then we
have always variables so let's modify
that this variables equal one we run
that again
that should be fine now we could now get
back to our training so we're expecting
that below three ebooks let's say equal
three ebooks we have a given learning
rate and then above that we have a
learning rate which decreases
exponentially so that's it
you see here that uh the training
process starts we did not really need to
print out any value because uh when we
set our variables to one It outputs this
so here we have learning rate scheduler
setting learning rate to
0.00999 that's practically 0.01 which is
what we had given year in this learning
races is practically just learning where
it's set in and then as time goes on
it's going to decrease its value and
then always output the current learning
rate
so as we carrying out the Australian
process recall that the aim of having to
work with this kind of linear rate
shadowless is that we want to
actually get the best of both worlds so
what we want is speed because uh a very
slow or very small learning rate doesn't
actual speed and so we want speed and
then we also want
stability when training so because we
want this tool we are going to use uh
modify our learning rates such that we
always get this throughout our training
process and so that's why whenever we're
starting our training we have high
learning rates which could ensure speed
and then as soon as we we have trained
for a given period of time or for a
given number of epochs and that we're
trying to approach this Global Minima
right here we now seek for stability by
reducing the learning rate such that we
don't get to this point and have to
diverge so if you want to more stable
kind of training process what we do is
reduce this learning rate
after the train is complete here's what
we get you could see that we have this
learning rate which is now modified
after a given number of ebooks so here
you see how the learning rates starts
decreasing as we go on with the training
process
and so that's how we Implement learning
rate shadowing but before moving on
let's check out this tutorial provided
by the AmEx net
project developers which talks of other
different learning rate scheduling
techniques so here we have this learning
rate scheduling with warm-up
[Music]
um yes a slanted triangular and as you
could see the learning
rate actually falls between these two
values here so we have all any rate
between
one and two so you could always Define
your max learning rate
and then your mean learning rate so you
could always have this and then with the
warm-up what we do is we are going to
increase this
learning rate linearly up to
um the max for a given number of epochs
and then once we attend this uh once we
get to this number of ebooks we now
start decreasing this learning rate so
here the decrease is linear so it's a
linear function we're using and then
once it gets to the minimum Landing rate
we just maintain that constant value
right up to the end so another uh
foreign
technique you could use here is we have
this linear increase that's the warm up
and then we decrease this exponentially
right up to this minimum value
now this technique of warm up was uh
developed in this paper by Priya goyal
at all and the found that having a
smooth linear warm-up in the learning
rate at the start of the training
improve the stability of the optimizer
and led to better Solutions then from
here we move on to the cosine alanin
scheduling method where there is this
smooth decrease in the learning rate
which is kind of resembling the cosine
function now this is what a cosine
function actually looks like so here we
have this
um and that so here's our cosine
function and then if you notice you'll
find that this portion actually looks
similar to what we have here
and now after we get to a given number
of ebooks we just maintain that so we
have defined a mean and then the Max and
then once we get to the mean we just
maintain that mean throughout then we
also have this stepwise Decay shadowing
let's take this off here you see how we
we start with the warm up so this
warm-up is kind of
like a method used very much in practice
and then from here we have this stepwise
reductions so we go in for this fixed
learning rate after a given number of
ebooks we now drop the learning rate and
then we drop it and so on and so forth
so here's a step wise
scheduling with warm up then from here
we have this cool down
where we follow the stepwise method and
then after a given number of epochs we
now reduce the learning rate linearly
hence the term cool down
we also have this one cycle
scheduling technique proposed by Leslie
n Smith and Nikolai topine and here's
what it looks like you see that we
increase that we have this warm up and
then this linear decrease once we get to
this initial position we also have again
this linear decrease with a different
slope uh with a
smaller slope and then once you get to
this minimum all this final minimum we
now just actually just maintain the
learning rate
now finally we have the cyclical
scheduling methods uh originally
proposed by Leslie n Smith uh the idea
of tactical uh increasing or psychically
increasing the degree and decreasing the
learning rate has been shown to give
faster conversions and more Optimal
Solutions so as you could see here we
are having the learning rate which is
going to be bouncing from the minimum to
the maximum as you could see here so we
have this linear increase to the Max and
then linear drop linear increase in your
drop and so on and so forth
and then finally we have this cyclical
cosine aniline scheduling right here we
see how we have the cosine Al nylene and
then we have this oh full cyclical
process as we go from the highest to the
lowest and and then this next cycle from
the meet between the mean and the max
that's this right to the mean learning
rate and then we take up this final
cycle from this quarter of the total so
we add 0.5 which is a quarter of two so
we start from this and then right to the
mean now notice also that as we go into
the cycle
the cycle lens keep increasing so we
move from this to this length and
finally this length based on the
scheduler you want to implement all you
need to do is to modify this scheduler
method right here the next callback
we'll be looking at is that of model
checkpointing in this model checkpoint
callback we are able to save the models
weights at some frequency so unlike
previously where after training like
with this after training our model we
get to low or rather we get to see if
the model like here so here we saved our
model or we save our weights after we're
done with the training yeah we could be
doing this with saving during the
training process and thanks to this
model checkpoint callback
now as usual we just copy this and then
we could check out on this documentation
for the significance of each and every
one of those arguments here we have the
file path so this is the file uh where
we are going to be saving our model
so here we have our checkpoint call back
and that's it we have model checkpoints
here we're going to Define this file
path and then what are we going to be
monitoring we're going to be monitoring
uh the validation loss which is what's
given to us by default
just like with the early stopping where
we had this monitor right here we are
going to look at our validation loss and
supposing we have this validation loss
and then our training loss so we're
going to look at our validation loss
which is this and then
save the model weights when we have this
minimal or the smallest validation loss
right here and then if you set the save
best only to true then we'll save only
this weights whereas one is false will
save this and also save the latest
weights
and then for this argument save weights
only if it's safe to if it's set to true
then we're gonna save only the weights
whereas if it's set to false then we're
going to be saving a model that's a full
model whether it's uh parameters then we
have the mode which is automatic like
since this validation loss since it's a
loss automatically this will be a mean
whereas if this is an accuracy or
Precision we're gonna have a Max right
here
so let's take this back to Auto and then
we have validation loss now the same
frequency when set to Epoch simply means
we're gonna do this saving after each
and every ebook where we could modify
this to say three so after three ebooks
we're gonna verify if our current model
is the best of all the previous models
that's if we've set this to true so if
we set this to true we're going to
verify if this model the current model
is the best if it's the best then we uh
overwrite this file path that's override
the file the wait file we've saved and
if it's not the best we continue
training so that said let's modify our
file path and then let's call this check
points that's it so we have this
checkpoints and then we run this cell
we have that and then we add this
callback right here so we have the
checkpoint
checkpoint callback
that's fine we run the training now and
see what we get
after training for over 20 perks we have
this two locks which you can notice here
this one well we've been told assets
written to checkpoints assets so you
could open up this checkpoints here and
then you'll see that we actually saving
this model and then we also have this
locked here that's after the seat Epoch
now let's understand why this login is
done after the first and also after the
seat ebook
just when training starts we have a
validation loss of 0.47 and so we're
supposing that since this is the first
then the model such as best state then
it moves to one which is greater than
this so the model State or the best
state is this one after the first ebook
this the model the first ebook or the
model of state of the first ebook is to
the best this doesn't beat the record
this doesn't
and then
you would see that here we have this
validation loss of 0.24 that is why the
model is now saved
from this model checkpointing section
we'll look at the reduce learning rate
on plateau
and then later on we'll have a dedicated
section for tensor mod
the way this learning rate or rather
reduce learning rate on Plato works is
that if you start training with a fixed
learning rate and then say you've
trained for over a hundred ebooks and
that the model performance after
110 Epoch so let's say we have 110 right
here so after this 110 ebooks or mobile
model performance doesn't improve so we
we still fix our learning rate but since
for the past
10 ebooks we haven't had an improvement
in the model's performance what we'll do
is we'll reduce the model's learning
rate by a given Factor so here is the
factor uh the patients our patients here
is 10 million that we're going to wait
for 10 ebooks before deciding whether
we're going to reduce the learning rate
or not the verbosity as usual the
quantity to be monitored in this case
the default is the validation loss the
mode automatic so if you want it to be
mean you could specify mean or Max but
setting it to automatic allows
tensorflow to automatically decide
whether it's a mean or Max in the case
of validation loss obviously it's going
to be a mean since our aim is to reduce
the validation loss as much as we can
then we have the mean Delta which takes
in a default value of
0.0001 and this means that if after say
10 epochs we have a change in the
validation loss but this change is less
than this mean Delta then we'll consider
that that isn't a change and hence we
are going to still reduce the learning
rate by this Factor right here we also
have the cooldown and then the minimum
learning rate below which we wouldn't we
wouldn't want to drop our learning rate
I subscribe here this cooldown is a
number of ebooks to wait before you
resuming normal operation after the
learning rate has been reduced we are
going to create this callback very
easily and this time around we're going
to monitor the validation accuracy so if
the validation accuracy doesn't increase
after two epochs we are going to reduce
the learning rate by a factor of 0.1
meaning that if we had a learning rate
of say
0.01 and that this validation accuracy
hasn't increased after the two epochs we
are going to reduce this such that this
becomes
0.01 times 0.1
which is this Factor right here
just as before we're gonna add this
Plateau callback and then
train our model
after training for five ebooks we can
observe that we have this learning rate
which has been reduced after the third
ebook and this is because
after this two epochs there is no
improvement in this initial validation
accuracy and so that's why the accuracy
is going to drop from 0.01 to 0.001
now that's it for this section thank you
for getting up to this point and see you
next time
hello everyone and welcome to this new
section in which we're gonna look at
different strategies of combating
overfitting and under feeding this
strategies will include data
augmentation as you could see here drop
out regularization early stopping
smaller Network usage hyper parameter
tuning and normalization so far in this
course we've mentioned the terms
overfitting and underfitting without
really getting in depth to what this two
actually mean now for overfeeding we'll
consider this plot of the loss versus
the number of epochs and then precision
versus number of ebooks with a loss
versus number of ebooks what would
generally have one model over 50
something like this so here we have the
training the validation loss and that
here we have the training loss so this
is just like or something a general
way of looking at this though this may
take different forms now that said as we
could see we have this two sets and the
loss versus number of ebooks plots
clearly we could see that the validation
and the training set initially start up
with a similar pattern sometimes you may
even have the the validation which comes
up like this so you can even have a
solution like this where the validation
performs even better than the training
set initially but generally when a model
overfits what we'll have will be this
kind of model where at some point the
model keeps doing well at the level of
the training and starts doing very
poorly in the validation set
we could replicate this with the
Precision apoc this could be Precision
accuracy recall or some other metric
which we've Chosen and what we could
have would be something like this
obviously you saw in the practice is it
isn't always like this but uh something
in this sense so you would have this uh
here you see you have the training
and then you have the validation right
here so what goes on is your model keeps
on doing very well for the training and
then with the validation at some point
it starts doing even oh very very poorly
and so the danger with this is if you
are considering uh working only with a
training set you may feel like you you
more ebooks or training over more ebook
is a good idea because you keep having
this great results like supposing we
have fixed this year and that your
training is like say 99 so you have 99
position score for or on your training
data and you're like wow this model will
do very well in the real world but this
is in generally the case because this
model actually has been
overfeated on your training data your
model has learned instead to modify his
weights based on the training data
instead of being able to extract useful
information or some intelligence from
the data which has been used in training
this model
the main cause of overfitting is having
a small data set and a large and complex
model which contains so many parameters
now if a model like say a deep neural
network has many parameters and you're
giving it a small data set then
obviously it's going to adjust its
parameters such that on this small data
set it performs exceptionally well so
you may come across a model which has
say uh 99.9 percent Precision or
accuracy just because the data you've
used to train the model has or was very
small
now in another case you may have uh say
a moderate sized data set and then uh
not just this kind of model of a very
large model so at the end of the day we
noticed that there has to always be a
balance between this uh data set and the
model size so this means that even if
you increase the data size and then you
also increase the model size your model
may still risk over feeding to better
understand this concept of overfitting
let's take this simple example supposing
that you have three subjects to master
our school let's say math
English and sports but when kids get to
school they are only taught mathematics
or they only taught English only taught
spots let's choose for example
mathematics so these kids get to school
and from the first year to the last year
they taught only mathematics it's clear
that when you evaluate this kid or when
you pick a kid at a random and evaluate
that kid in mathematics the kid will
tend to have a better oh and are both
average result in mathematics compared
to keys from other schools
but when tested on subjects like English
and sports
that may not be the case and this is
because the English and spots weren't
taught at school
and so if you are evaluated on only what
you were taught you tend to have very
high scores like this and then what if
we start to evaluate on stuff the kids
were not taught you'll notice that those
kids will then start having poorer
results because those kids haven't taken
out some time to master English and
sports and so you may end up with a kid
who was able to show for example that
sine Square X Plus cos Square x equal
one but can't tell you the past tense of
eat now it's clear that to readjust this
situation the kids have to be taught all
the subjects such that there is a
balance that these kids need and
obviously this balance will come in a
way that the keys now perform better in
these two subjects and
uh because they have had part of the
time they used to study maths allocated
for English in sports they may perform
uh slightly less than before in maths
but at least what's important to notice
this time around they can now Express
themselves better in English or practice
some spots let's now take this other
example supposing we're training a model
which predicts the presence of a car in
an image and then you fat you feed your
model with this kind of theater then
after training your model where you get
a test that model is on this kind of
real world theater it's clear that even
if you had very great results with a
previous dinner in this uh working with
this or testing on this new data set
right here you wouldn't have those
amazing results you had previously and
so it's important in that not only
should your data be large enough or get
as much useful data as you can but
ensure that your training data
represents or looks like your test data
or looks like what you're gonna be
having in production as that's really
what matters what matters is the fact
that you have a model in production
which works well or which has a high
accuracy and not a model and your
notebook which has say 100 accuracy on
your Trend data whereas on production it
doesn't perform very well
now moving on to under feeding it turns
out that here our model becomes way too
simple for it to even be able to extract
information from our data so we may have
a validation data and then our training
data like this and then
there is this huge gap between our
current loss and the minimum possible
loss we could also have this at the
level of say let's say accuracy so yeah
we could have accuracy and then we have
our validation and then training
and we have see accuracy hundred percent
let's say we have one right here and
then our model is still too simple that
we just end up say at 0.6 or 60 percent
accuracy in this kind of situation our
data or the relative size of our data
as compared to the model may be too
large so you could even have a situation
where this debtor is smaller than what
we had here so you did it could be small
like this but if your model is way too
simple
say we have just this very small model
then you may face this problem of under
feeding
it also turns out that sometimes you may
have a situation where you have even a
very complex model but a model still
under fits and that's because that model
hasn't been built in a way that it could
extract useful information from this
data now if you can recall in the
section where we're predicting the car
price we had a situation where a model
we use a simple dense layer that's we
use a simple single lens layer with just
two parameters
and we have this fixed data set
but once we increased our
stacked up more dense layers we found
out that we're able to get better
training and validation
mean average error values there are
several ways in which we could mitigate
this problem of overfitting the very
first one we'll look at is that of
collecting more data so it's important
to lay hands on as much data as you can
this data has to be representative of
what the model would see in real life
and this data should be as diverse as
possible
even after collecting more data to solve
this problem of overfitting we could use
data augmentation now what is data
augmentation all about
supposing we have this image cell right
here the cell image we have here
which happens to be parasitized
now instead of having just this in our
data set we could have this image right
here modified such that we now have more
data to train on so this means that in
the case where initially we had say 20
000 images so we have 20 000 images now
after doing data augmentation after
modifying each and every image we now
have a data set of 80 000. now we're
considering 80 000 because we suppose
that each image is going to be flipped
as we've just done right here so we take
this image we rotate it we have this
other image the same level obviously
still parasitized and then we flip again
and get this image we flip get this
image flip get this image we see that we
now have instead of just this one we
have four others this actually means oh
we multiplying this by five so this is a
hundred thousand since we have it now
uh one two three four five examples for
this single example we had initially it
should also be noted that there are many
other data augmentation strategies for
this kind of image data so apart from
flipping as we've just done we could
crop just a potion we could add some
noise to this data we could modify the
contrast we could modify the brightness
and carry out so many other operations
and there is no particular data
augmentation strategy which works for
all problems this means that uh when you
have a particular problem you would have
to try different augmentation strategies
and then be able to select the one which
works for your data now that said we
have drop out
to better understand this notion of drop
out we'll consider this simple neural
network right here
now if you could recall the reason why
we have models which overfeed is because
we are working with very complex models
with many parameters
now in order to reduce the complexity of
this neural network what we could do is
take off for example this interaction
between this neuron and others previous
neurons right here so this means that
when training our model we are only
going to consider that we have in this
hidden layer just this two neurons right
here so all those connections here
become useless now this has the effect
of simplifying our Network as what we
have as output now that's after carrying
out the drop out operation looks like
this so we have now a connection which
look like this
now
this particular case is an example of a
drop out we drop our ratio equal
0.3 or let's say 0.333 as we're dropping
out exactly one third of all the
connections or or rather one set of all
our neurons right here
and if r equal to third what we'll be
left with will be this so we'll take
this off and we'll be left just with
this neural network to train right here
we see that we could leave from this
very complex model to a simplified model
via this drop out
operation and this has an overall effect
of mitigating overfeeding
the next step we could take is that of
regularization to better understand
regularization suppose we have this
model with weights WJ so we have
um say n weights
and this weights are free to take up any
value
as we've seen previously the fact that
those weights can take up just any value
may lead to overfeeding as now those
weights can be adjusted to fit on the
training dealer in a very perfect manner
so this means that we could have a model
which picks out each and every Point
like this so we have this kind of model
and we have this so we have this model
which picks up every Point like that
whereas
if we restrain this weight to
stay in a given range then we may end up
with something like this so we may end
up with a model which looks simplified
like this because it doesn't have as
much Freedom as this other model
now the problem with this model is if
now you put in like you're putting this
new theater you'll find that this one
will try to
pull out like this and then your
prediction will be somewhere around here
and so if for example we're having
horsepower on the x-axis and then yeah I
want to predict the price of a car
let's do same here we have the price and
then the horsepower
then it happens that we have this car
with this
um very high horsepower this model
because it is over fitted on this
training dealer will predict this very
low price whereas this model which is
generalized on
this training theater
will tend to predict a more reasonable
price
now it should be another year that
because this model was able to go
through each and every point would have
a training loss of almost zero whereas
now when we give it this new data it
doesn't perform well whereas with this
we wouldn't have a training loss of zero
but when given new dealer at least we're
gonna have reasonable predictions
so coming back to regularization our aim
is to ensure that this weights because
this uh model can represented as this
function and this function
is made of those weights
and so since when we're doing training
our aim is to ensure that we minimize
the loss then we could include this
weight in the computation of the loss
this means that we have our loss which
is now equal the loss would have
normally plus this regularization
constant times the sum of this weight of
each and every weight Square now this is
known as L2 regularization whereas here
we have L1 regularization where we're
summing up the absolute value of each
and every weight for now we're just
gonna explain how regularization helps
in mitigating that problem of
overfitting by restraining those weights
in a given range
so let's have your loss
equal
L does initial loss plus let's call this
r
now if our aim is to minimize this loss
then obviously this L will be minimized
and the r will be minimized and so if
we're trying to minimize this year
all this sum in general then it would
have that overall effect of restraining
these weights in a given range
especially as we know that when we
Square very large values these values
become even larger and So to avoid this
our weights will tend to take up smaller
values which fall under a smaller range
this L2 regularization is also known as
weight decay
it should be noted that the main
difference between this L2
regularization and L1 regularization is
that in trying to restrain the range of
values which this weights can take up
the L1 regularization has that negative
effect of
making many of those weights to take up
values around zero that's values very
very small or take up many zero values
so this will lead to sparse models as
compared to the L2 regularization and
that's why in practice we generally use
the L2 regularization
that said we move on to L is stopping
which we've seen already
in Alice stopping as we have seen if we
have our model let's say we have
precision
uh validation position and then the
training position which keeps on
increasing and then we have this limit
here of one a hundred percent so we have
the Precision and we have our epochs and
then after a while this starts dropping
and this starts dropping simply because
our model is now trying to
overfeed on this data it's been trained
on and so we have to stop training once
we notice that the validation
performance isn't improving any longer
so this means that after a certain
number of ebooks we are going to stop
the training and I would send this
already in the previous section we've
seen it but to really guy like this and
then we had seen it practically
then another thing to do is to reduce
the size of the network or use a less
complex Network our next step will be to
properly tune our hyper parameters hyper
parameters like by size drop our rate
regularization rate and the learning
rate can affect our model
and dictate whether this model will
overfit or not now if you look at the
batch size
training with a larger bite size May
speed up our training process but
working with smaller batch sizes have a
regularization effect which help reduce
overfeeding
and so according to Young Lacon friends
don't let friends use many batches
larger than 32.
for the drop hour rate we've seen this
already increasing the drop our rate
means
we are making the model simpler
and the regularization rate increasing
the regulation rate means we reducing
the effect of overfitting and then
finally
picking too small of a learning rate
mainly to overfeeding so in general we
have some hyper parameters to tune and
they are not only limited to this as you
may have many other hyper parameters
depending on your problem
now the fact that normalization
introduces extra parameters mu Sigma
which bring in some noise in the model
has that regularization effect which
help reduce overfeeding so
if you're including batch Norm in your
model then you could feel free to reduce
the dropout rate
since this normalization layer already
brings in that regularization effect
from here we look at ways of mitigating
the problem of over under feeding so
with underfitting we could
use more complex models
we could also collect more data we see
that this solution uh falls in the two
that's both over fitting and
underfitting here is always a good team
to collect more theater or more clean
and representative data
so from here we have you could also
improve the training time now note that
you could have this model like let's
take this and then we have here you've
trained and then you have the validation
so here you have the vowel and then you
have the train and then you've been
training for over say a thousand ebooks
and then you feel like uh the model may
not perform any better
now several scientists have reported
that many times they've given up on a
model and then come back later after
forgetting to stop the training process
and notice that this model kept on
performing were much better so sometimes
you don't have to give up on your model
so you could train or you could increase
the strain in time then again we have
hyper parameter tuning which could help
in making your model more performant and
we have normalization which stabilizes
the training process and leads to better
performance in the model we now see
practically how the drop out could be
implemented with tensorflow so here we
have this drop out layer which takes as
argument the rate the dropout rate noise
shape and the seating to better
understand how and why we need to use
seeding is simply in the case where one
reproduce possible experiment so if you
want to apply drop out in this layer
with a drop R rate of 0.2 then we'll be
taking off one neuron out of this five
neurons to make our model simpler and
avoid overfeeding now in doing so we may
take this one or this or this one or
this or this other one so it's a random
choice now if you want to fix this
choice so that this experiment can be
reproducible then we can set the seed so
that each time we run the experiment
it's going to be exactly the same neuron
which is going to be taken off getting
back to the code the way we could use
this is by importing the drop out layer
so here we just have this drop out we
run that and it's fine and then we could
include this drop out right here so we
could have here drop out let's let's say
drop out rate drop out rate equal 0.2
now you could always increase this rate
so let's have that and then we have the
drop out and then drop out our other
rate equal drop out rate that's fine we
could place this out here but wouldn't
would want to drop out here anyway you
could always include the drop out at
this level depending on how the model
responds to this Dropout which has been
added here so let's add this drop out
and then at the drop out right here
bearing in mind that we could always add
more drop out layers and increase the
drop hour rate or even reduce this rate
so that's fine we run our model and as
you could see right here this drop out
has no parameters from this we look at
regularizers we'll see how to implement
the L2 regularizer and the L1
regularizer so here we have TF Keras and
then we have this regular risers right
here so if you select L2 you should
follow on this page now once you get
this you see you have this TF that Kara
regularizes L2 and then you specify the
regularization rate so let's copy this
out and then get back to our model
a level of our model let's come back to
the definition of the conf2d so here we
have this kernel regularizer and this
current regularizer that we use in
carrying out regularization so here we
have this conf2d and then we simply
specify the kernel regularizer we have
kernel
regularizer which is equal this
regularizer right here now let's take
this off and there we go we have this
Canon regularizer which is now our L2
regularizer you could always take this
off and then from here and you have
from tensorflow that Keras the
regularizers
in part
L2 so that you could also import L1 so
run that
it's correct that that's regularizer
regular Riser okay so that's fine uh we
get back to our model right here and
then we have just L2 now you could have
this taken up from your
and then you add it out here so pattern
valid activation relu and that okay so
we have this and then we add our
regularizer and that's fine now you
could also do this for the dense layers
so just right here you could have kernel
regularizer and that should be fine so
this is how we implement the weight
Decay with tensorflow now you could
always modify these parameters so let's
let's have
Decay R regularization rate
um 0.01 so that's it and then we run our
model that should be fine and we could
go ahead and retrain this model
that's it for the section thank you for
getting up to this point and see you
next
hello everyone and welcome to this new
section in which we'll delve deep into
implementing data augmentation with
tensorflow 2. the first method will use
in implementing data augmentation will
be using this tensorflow image model
which is made of these different
functions now this is just a few of
those functions and you could check out
the resonate documentation so we'll be
able to do stuff like adjusting
brightness contrast gamma adjustments
saturation adjustment flipping Left
Right flipping up down and rotation
using this TF image is known to be a
more flexible way of implementing data
augmentation as we could alter an input
image with all these different functions
given to us the next method we'll use or
will Implement in this course is by
working with the Keras layers and
although we're limited by the number of
the documentation in layers made
available to us this method permits us
to carry out that augmentation more
efficiently and hence speeds up the
training process now to find a balance
between these two methods we could
Implement our own custom Keras layers
and that's exactly what we're gonna do
in this section we're now looking at how
to implement data augmentation with
tensorflow so we're gonna get into
tensorflow than images so here we have
TF
here is layers we actually in Keras
closes up and tf.image actually so we
have the cf. image with all these
methods which we could use indeed
augmentation we call that in order to do
the documentation we'll basically
modifying the images while keeping the
labels fixed
so that said as you could see here we
have this several methods let's check
out on this overview and we should be
able to get this list of methods so here
we have
um the list of methods and we have the
categories so here we have image
adjustments working with bounding boxes
here is for object detection we're here
to get into this uh here is cropping
flipping and
decoding and encoding so this is what we
have now if we get back to the top we'll
have this adjustments
um okay so we have this resize which
you've seen already
and then we have this adjustments we
could adjust the brightness contrast
gamma here GPA quality saturation
brightness contrast you
saturation and per image standardization
now notice that this ones here are
random so we are adjusting our image
randomly as you can see we have random
brightness whereas here we actually
adjusting this brightness with
some fixed parameters so if you click on
this I just brightness right here you
see we have this image and we have this
fixed Delta which we choose whereas if
it's random let's get back if it's
random that will be fixed randomly so if
we click on this random brightness you
see we're just given a Max Delta because
we just all we need to pass in here as a
range and then we are going to randomly
pick a delta in that range
so that's it for this image adjustments
we also have the scrapping so we could
crop out some parts of the image we
could crop all those Central across we
could crop and resize so this means
if we have this image so we have this
image and it's 224 by 224
and then we want to do a crop we could
do a center crop like this we could take
this Center crop
sorry for that we have this Center crop
and we have this new image right here
which is this center now after getting
this image let's suppose we have now
this smaller image of shape say
150 by 150 and then what we could do now
is to resize this so that we get this
shape which we need to pass into the
model so we could resize this hence the
reason why we're using the crop uh crop
battery size crop and resize right here
and you could always as well just crop
and then do the resize manually so
that's it uh we have flipping rotating
so flipping we have an image we flip it
left right up down or random randomly so
let's get the same thing but this time
around we're doing it randomly uh
rotation and then the transposition of
the image
so as you could see tensorflow gives us
all those methods which we could use in
modifying our images and hence
augmenting our dealer
so here we will Define this method
visualize so you could see this clearly
we have the original image and then we
have the augmented image now in here we
have
subplot
we want just one line two columns and
this will occupy the first position that
in that two column space so here now we
have this in show which takes in the
original and then we repeat this so here
we have this second position and then we
have the augmented
augmented
okay so that's our visualize method now
what we do is we are going to get the
original image so let's say we have this
original image which is equal
an element which we take from our data
set so we have train data set and then
let's just pick one element so we have
uh this
and then we take just one element from
our data set now that's it and this
should output the level so we should
have the level and there we go so we
have the original image here and then we
now work with augmented image we get
this augmented image and to obtain some
augmented image we are going to modify
this original image to do this
multiplication we are going to make use
of this methods which we've seen already
so yeah let's pick out this flip left
right click on this flip left right and
see what we get so all we need to do is
just pass the image so let's copy this
and then what we have here is our flip
left right and our image which has been
passed
that's fine we have original image so
that's it now we have this augmented
image we run that and then we could go
ahead and visualize this augmentation so
here we have original image and
augmented
image okay so we run this and see what
we get so that's it you see that now in
your data on this set you'll not only
get this image right here you not only
get this one but you would get this and
this so this means our data set now will
be multiplied by two
let's check on other augmentation
strategies let's get back
um here we go we have flip up down this
similar to what we've seen already okay
let's check out let's do this random
flip up down and then uh let's click on
this and then Rotation by 90 degrees so
here we have this image similar and then
they could specify the seed so here we
have the random flip up down
from that and then yeah we have
random
sleep
up down
okay so we run that again we have
augmented image and then we visualize
you see that it happens that it's
exactly the same image which is I'll put
it let's run this again
and now what we get is inside this so
notice how the difference between these
two images
so that's it the next will be this Rod
90 degrees click on that you could
always feel free to click and then
understand what it actually means like
yeah with rotate image counter clockwise
by 90 degrees now
um let's take this off we know clockwise
is this direction
so rotating counter clockwise means
we'll be rotating it in this direction
by 90 degrees
so that said let's take this off and
then we have Rock 90 we run that and
there we go
okay so as you can see we've rotated
this by 90 degrees and the
anti-clockwise direction
we can also try out this adjust
brightness and random saturation so
let's get back to this notebook we have
here adjust
brightness
and we run this visualize
we have this error missing positional
argument so let's get back to this and
understand how it's used we check and
adjust brightness
and there we go we need to pass in a
Delta so we have to pass in this Delta
now
this Delta should be in the range
negative one one and as you could see
when you add this Delta it basically
just adds up to each and every pixel we
have so this one turns to 1.1 this 11
times 11.1 and so on and so forth and we
told you that this Delta is a scalar and
it's an amount to add to the pixel
values so let's go ahead and add this
Delta
let's have that we add the delta
and we have 0.1 so we run that again and
it should be fine okay so that's fine we
now visualize
and that's what we get you'll notice
that there's uh some difference with
this like this one appears brighter than
this and let's go ahead and increase
this let's take 0.8 and then have that
okay so you see we are able to modify
this brightness
we could also include the random
saturation
random saturation and we have the
original image let's get back to
documentation for random saturation and
see what we need to pass in so there we
go we have this image we pass in the
lower and the upper limit so here
um let's find this lower upper limit
we told you we're going to get an error
if the upper is less on the lower which
is logical lower should be less on the
upper and then if the lower is less than
zero so we have to ensure that we're
dealing with values greater than or
equal to zero so getting back here we
have saturation that and then we have
lower
um let's say two and then upper let's
say 12. take this off run again and
visualize
okay so that's fine so you see we've
added some random saturation and that's
what we get
we could obviously reduce this we could
make this fall on the Range
um zero one and
here is what we get okay
we now check out on cropping let's check
out this Central crop
yeah we have Central crop
Central crop and the original image
so that's what we have let's make sure
we
understand exactly how it's meant to be
used so here we have this and then
there's a central fraction so yeah I'll
explain how this works now where X is
the central 50 of the image and
it is a float which lies between zero
and one as you could see here 0.5 has
been peaked means that we're gonna pick
50 of the image but uh this portion of
the image we're gonna pick has to be
centralizers has to be surrounding the
center so that said we'll understood how
that works we can now put that let's say
0.3 run that and see what we get
okay so you see we get this position
right here now what if we expand this to
like say 0.8 we should we expect to have
some black regions now
we run that
and you see we have some black regions
so it's actually centralized
um let's take this off
you see it's actually centralized and we
the reason why we have something like
this is actually cutting out like this
and something like this
so this is what we get in
here
something like this okay so this is what
we get when we do this Central crop
now the way we're gonna integrate this
augmentation in our data pipeline is
going to be similar to the way we did
with the resize rescue so just like we
we use this map method we are going to
reuse this same method for our
augmentation here
um let's suppose we are gonna let's add
this code and then
Define our augment method
so we have this let's put this down and
okay so yeah we let's just have your
augment we have this augment method
image uh level and then
what we'll do is we'll take the image
and then for that image we're gonna have
um the rotate 90 degrees
of that image
then next we are going to have
adjust saturation
and then pass in the image and specify
the
saturation Factor so here we have our
saturation Factor equal say 0.3 now you
could always feel free to visualize this
so you don't get to
quality augment your Dieter that said
yeah we could have this saturate
oh we didn't copy that anyway this flip
left right let's come back to this we
have this adjust saturation
we could check that out
and let's have it here
okay we have that so we run this and
visualize to see exactly what's going to
look like
we modified an image to original image
and then run it again
okay so this is what we get now that's
fine we can also include the flip left
right so here we have image
um CF dot image
flip left right and then what we do is
we have we could return the image and
the level so that's fine
then we could also just simply include
this resize rescale in this augment so
here we have uh image
and the level equal resize rescale which
takes in the image and the level so we
resize and rescale before doing the
augmentation so that's it now we have
this augment method defined we could now
instead of doing this here so here we
have augments
now another thing we want to do before
doing the map is actually shuffling so
we'll modify the order in which we're
doing things now here we have this
um Trend data set you could have that
and then we have the Trinity set right
here
dot Shuffle
dot match and Dot refresh so yeah that's
what we have and then we just include
the map in right here so instead of
doing the mapping before the shuffling
we just do it
um after the shuffling and there we go
let's now have this it's basically this
um with augment so we just have that and
then there we go we have this map okay
so we we now have that for the training
and then we could close this up
so that's fine
we repeat the same process for the
validation and the testing so yeah we're
gonna modify just as we do the training
we have here our validation
then we include this map right here map
resize reskill now notice how we are not
augmenting the validation and test data
sets so here we have the validation and
then we now do the same for the testing
anyway for the testing we had we only
did them we only use the map that is we
only did the resize rescale so that's
fine we will now take this off train
validation that's off
um that's fine
okay so yeah we have our test data we
have our train dinner and then we have
our validation data
at this point everything is set up we
could now rerun ourselves so we start
out with training so that's fine we'll
come back get back to this we have our
data
we run all the cells and uh model
created so yeah we're gonna work only
with this sequential API
and skip out all this other methods of
creating models once we're done with
that uh we get right up to this level
okay so now we get into training
that's fine I'll compile the model and
we wouldn't use any callbacks for now
take that off and start training
we're now done with training and we'll
see the results right here so as you
could see the model performs very poorly
and we'll try to understand why the
model doesn't perform as well as it
performed without the data augmentation
now if you can recall though what we did
for the data augmentation was that we
rotated the image about by 90 degrees
anti-clockwise we adjusted the image of
the images saturation and then we flip
the image left right
but taking a look at the kind of data
set we're dealing with this saturation
shouldn't be a great idea and this is
simply because if we look at each and
every one of this what differentiates
are parasitized cell like this one and
this uninfected cell is this patches we
have right here so you'll notice I would
pass that cell we have we generally have
this kind of patches whereas with the
uninfected cell we practically have no
patch and with this whereas here you see
you could see this patches and so
rotating or flipping Left Right wouldn't
change much about that so that is
acceptable now the problem with
modifying the contrast is when you
modify the contrast you tend to
make the parasitized cells and
uninfected cells less differentiable and
so it isn't a good idea in this case to
modify the contrast or saturation of the
image
let's take this example so we could
clearly understand why this saturation
data augmentation strategy isn't a good
idea so yeah right here what we'll do is
we just copy out this and then paste
here we'll take out just two uh elements
from our data set and then here we have
this one
four and
two I plus one
and we have the IM show from here we
create another subplot
there we go we have that and this one
now is a saturation so TF image dot
adjust saturation
that's it and it will pass in the image
and that's what we have so here we have
this first subplot and this other
subplot we have that too now or we could
run this and see what we get
um isn't a positional argument that is
the 0.3 the the saturation rate so here
we have 0.3 we're using exactly what we
used previously so here we have that and
that's what we have in this example we
have both in uninfected cells so
wouldn't actually see much difference
it's through this it's modified this
tool is modified but there isn't much
difference let's take a prosthetized
cell if we run this again hopefully you
get a parasite so okay as you could see
here
um let's take this off as you could see
on this process they sell what could
clearly should model that this is a
process I saw is this patch we have
right here but when we adjust the
saturation it turns into this and you'll
notice that this parts that cell now
looks more like an uninfected cell so
the model isn't able to differentiate
between these two clearly so we see
clearly that
um using the adjust saturation the
augmentation strategy isn't a great idea
let's comment this part and that's fine
now we're going to modify our strategy
so just right here
what we had previously we're gonna take
this off so we comment this and then
we'll retrain our model
and so yeah we retrain our model after
modifying our data augmentation strategy
we run this again
and after training as you can see we get
this results now we check out this loss
that's what we get for the loss and if
we look at the accuracy we see that it
looks more like what we had previously
though
we still have that maximum validation
accuracy of about 94 and the train
accuracy of about 99 right here and
though the the augmentation strategy
hasn't closed this Gap we had between
the training and validation accuracy
with seeing all the sections how
decrementation will be very instrumental
in helping reduce this gap between the
training and the validation scores so
far we've been applying the
documentation by using the image methods
now the other way we could apply the
documentation is by directly making use
of Keras layers so you come right here
tf.keras layers as you could see and
then you'll notice that among those
layers we have this layers
which parameters do modifications on
images like with this random contrast
which permits us randomly adjusts
contrast during training here we have
the definition of this layers random
contrast layer and we have this
attributes right here
now apart from those random contrast we
have the random crop we have the random
flip and you could always get all these
definitions get back to yeah let's have
this flip now the mode horizontal and
vertical so we're gonna flip it both
horizontally and vertically we could
also have other modes like horizontal
that's
kind of a left right flip you have
vertical kind of up down flip we have
horizontal and vertical which is a
mixture of the two and the default is
horizontal vertical as we've just seen
right here
we also have this random rotation which
you could see random translation
random Zoom so you could randomly Zoom
the data you're training on and you also
have this resizing so we had looked at
results and previously but not actually
under that augmentation so we we did the
resize using TF image now you could also
do this resizing if you have this
resizing layer now here you have the
height and the width as we had uh
similarly to what we had in the image we
could scroll down and check on others
we don't really find anyone here we
could scroll back up and that's it
anyway what's important to notice that
you could create or you could Implement
data augmentation via two main ways
using the TF image and using those Keras
layers now we are going to look at how
to re-implement those developmentation
strategy we had previously via the Keras
layers so here we had this
rotation so we have rotation and we had
the flip left right so we'll get back to
documentation and then what do we have
here we have this
random flip right here and then we're
going to select the mode to horizontal
since we're doing left right flip so we
copy this out we have that layer random
flip let's put this just below so this
is the augmentation this is augmentation
using CF image
so TF image augment and then this is
augmentation using uh Keras layers so
tf.keras the layers augment okay so here
we have our augment it takes the image
and the level
but since we actually building Keras
layers we are not going to take this
this way we're going to have augment uh
layers
it's just a way of differentiating
between these two augment and augment
layers which is a sequential model so we
have the sequential uh we're going to
make use of the sequential API so you
have the keras.sequential and then just
right in here we are going to specify
all those different steps and so we
copied this out from the documentation
let's just paste it out here we have
this random flip so we're going to use
this random flip right here let's take
this let's import random flip from the
layers so we have your Keras layers
there we go we'll import random flip now
we could have this we have random
flip okay so we have the random flip
imported and then the other one is that
rotation let's get back and we have here
um rotation let's check on that we have
us scroll up and
let's just do a quick search so here we
have rotation okay so yeah we have
random rotation and don't forget we're
rotating 90 degrees in the
anti-clockwise direction so here we have
to be careful to make sure we
re-implement that same kind of rotation
we had seen before now here we have this
definition we have a factor field mode
reflect interpolation by linear uh the
seed for producibility full value and
that's it now let's check down here and
understand better this Factor
now this Factor we have here is actually
this two pool
and this Tuple is going to represent our
range to better understand this range uh
you should note that it's like each and
every one of this represents a fraction
of 2 pi now what is pi pi equals 180
degrees so 2 pi is 360 degrees so we're
looking for a fraction of 360 degrees
now recall that we're going
anti-clockwise by 90 degrees like we're
just trying to re do this exact same
thing we have with the TF image so here
we're gonna look for a way to get 90
degrees from this 360. and to do that we
need to divide this by four in other
words it means we're going to get 25
percent off
this 360 and 25 percent of 360 is 90
degrees so uh 90 degrees not percent so
that said we want to get uh 25 and
that's fine now from what is given to us
here
this is we present as a single flow this
value which is for both the upper and
the lower Bound for instance this
results in an output in an output
Rotation by a random amount in this
range
um
a positive value means rotating
counterclockwise while negative means
rotating clockwise now we're interested
in rotating clock counterclockwise is
anti-clockwise that we're actually
interested in rotating this way recall
it was this this is clockwise so we're
not interested in this we're interested
in this anti-clockwise 90 degrees
rotation so we take positive values and
then we'll try to ensure that it lies in
a given range now given that we are
actually picking this random numbers and
unlike the root 90 method we are seeing
which was somehow fixed yeah what we'll
do is we could just pick a range between
say 90 degrees
and say
90.1 degrees or any value very close to
90. so that said uh recall is going to
be positive unlike uh if it was
clockwise it will be negative so here
we're going to pick the
0.25 because we want to get 25 of this
360 so we have 0.25 that's positive 0.25
up to say
0.2 let's say five zero one so let's
pick out this range so we'll work in
this range so that we'll be around this
90 degree that we're actually looking
for now that said since we've taken 0.25
0.205 or 201 what we'll have here is
um 25 of 2 pi which is 90 degrees so
it's going to be translating into 90
degrees
and a value very close and 90 degrees so
it will be like 90 points uh value very
close or point zero zero whatever
degrees so it's going to be around this
so we pick this up and that's fine now
we assure it's anti-clockwise because we
as with pictures to be positive now the
fill mode and the fuel values will just
be the default values even the
interpolation two so that said we get
back to the code let's copy this out
right here random rotation copy this out
get back to the code let's include
random rotation here so we have random
rotation okay random rotation that's
fine uh we could now run this
let's run this cell and then
get back to our method or this
layer we're trying to construct right
here so here we have the random flip and
then the random rotation
now we started in this other method with
the rotation so yeah we're going to redo
that now we have this random rotation
random rotation okay and then we have
this Factor so we just do exactly what
we just agreed to put so we have the
factor it's simple take 0.25 and
0.62501 okay now we have that which is
for the rest we take the default value
so we don't need to put those values so
that's fine we've done with this first
layer the next layer will be this random
flip so we just put out this random flip
let's copy this
copy that and then paste it out here now
we have our random flip we've decided on
the mode take that off
and that's fine now this is horizontal
so let's have this is horizontal okay so
we have this random flip and that
and there we go we have our layer uh
sequential layer okay now let's take
this off
and that's fine so we have this
augmented layers all this augment layers
which will run this time around
horizontal is not defined now let's use
this small case
[Music]
um
horizontal
and run again
horizontal still not defined as a string
horizontal
run again then we could redefine an
augment method let's call this method
augment layer and then this takes in the
image
image layer
uh sorry levels
and then what we'll do is we're gonna
return this augment layers which we just
created and then pass in the image
specify that training is equal true
that's okay and then we send out the
levels so here we're gonna take this
augment layers as we're going to take
the image and pass into this layer right
here
is going to rotate the image and then
into this other layer which is going to
flip that image so we get our output
which has been augmented and we have our
levels we run this run this and then we
get to this here where we have our
augment and we have augment layer so we
call the augment layer method right here
we call this method that's fine we run
that and everything is okay
now after running this training we have
this Arrow so it shows that we have an
error at a level of the shapes now let's
get back
the problem here is we forgot to do this
resizing before the data augmentation so
we could copy this out and then put out
this resizing here we have the image and
levels uh level let's say emission level
we have that and then we resize and
reskill after resizing and rescaling we
now do the augmentation so we run this
again
and then we run the string
as you can see all is well we will now
look at another way of creating of doing
data augmentation before doing that we
should also note that instead of doing
this precisory skill using the TF image
as we have done here that is using this
TF image resize and then by dividing by
255 as we just did we could also use the
resizing and rescaling layers so right
here we're gonna include those layers
here we have resizing
and then reskill
we run that
and then just here we're going to
include that resize rescue so here we
say resize rescale layers
okay so now we have this our sequential
API and then we always start with
resizing so we have the resizing take
this off
and have this yeah we're gonna put uh M
size we have M size M size okay and then
we do the rescaling so we have rescaling
take this off
and we do the rescaling
so here we have this taken off
one divided by 255. okay so now we have
those layers which are responsible for
resizing and rescaling uh resizing and
re-skilling so we'll see how we'll
replace this method in doing the
recitary skill so that's it let's get
back to this augment we had augment
layer right here
after getting this image we do resize
rescale and layer so we do the recital
skill on the image before the
documentation let's take this off now
and this should be fine now since we've
built this resize rescale layers we
could replace this here or Smasher scale
layers even for the test set and then we
do same
um for this this already fine augment
layer as well we've seen already for the
validation we have resize rescale layers
okay so that's fine we run this run the
validation run the train and that's fine
we then train our model and see what we
get so that's it our model is training
everything is working well now let's
pause this and then
check out this other interesting way of
doing this data augmentation so as of
now we've seen how to do the
documentation by using TF image and then
by building this layers now we'll see
the importance of building these layers
but before looking at uh this importance
it's important to note uh this and that
is a fact that when you're working with
a TF image you have more flexibility as
with those layers you are kind of like
restrained to what you could do with the
augmentation though this
um layers already have many
common data augmentation strategies like
the rotation the zoom the crop the
flipping and the artist nonetheless when
you're working with a TF image you would
see that you have many more operations
you could do like if you open up this TF
image right here you see you have many
more methods and you could do many more
stuff with this anyway getting back to
our code
we have to note that the advantage of
this layers is that you could embed this
into the model itself now let's explain
supposing you have let's take this off
supposing you have your training
pipeline here so you have that TF data
you do the shuffling you do the mapping
you do prefetching caching and
everything you need to do like with your
training data so yeah using your data
and then next after doing all this
resizing and scaling and everything you
now pass this into your model so uh you
pass this into your model and then you
train your model and have all your
results now
when you want to test this model you
will actually still need to do resizing
and rescaling so you still need to
ensure that you resize your image
and then you also ensure that you
rescale your image before passing to the
model now if you recall like let's let's
go down let's get down here you'd see
under the testing section let's look at
this under the testing section
that we made use of this test data
and this test data as we have seen from
here was already resized and reskilled
so if you check here you see we have
done some resizing and reskilling right
here now what if you have to take this
uh this year model which you've trained
into another setup and obviously in that
new setup you will still need to resize
and rescale because
just like here before testing your model
you have to resize and reskill
so what if we in put this resizing and
rescaling in the model so if we embed
this resize on rescale in the model it
means that no matter where we go with
this model we don't need to resize and
Rescue all we need to do now let's we
need we'll take this off all right I
will take this and put in the model so
all we need to do now is just to pass in
your data without the resize not
rescaling and the job is done
so now we're gonna see how to do this
with this augment rather with the resize
rescale layers which we've just seen we
also do with the augment but the augment
isn't very useful since in testing time
we don't make use of documents uh what's
more important here to notice the
resizing and rescaling although if you
can include this augment layers into
your model and make the training faster
anyways let's go ahead and see how this
is done so firstly you have the layers
which you've built you've had document
layers and then you've had the resize
rescale layers which we have had here so
all we need to do is to get to this
model right here and then after the
input layer you just have the resize
rescale layers and that's it and then
you have augment
augment layers
so here you have resize rescale layers
and augment layers and that's all so
with this you don't need to do any
resizing or scaling on your input
because this is going to be done or this
are layers which are now part of your
model
and then year two you don't really need
to specify this image size you could now
have this as known and then yeah you
have that so you could put in any image
and then the resizing and rescaling will
be done in that model such that you
could put this model to use this model
in any environment and all you need to
do is to pass in the image and you have
your corresponding output now we've
modified this model we need to also
modify the way we working with our
testing and training validation data
sets so let's get back to this right
here we have the
down here we have this augment augment
and then we have this test data set so
with the test data set now we do not
need to do this again so we just commend
this because we don't need to resize or
skill anymore now with the validation
you see with the validation we do not
need to do this mapping anymore
you see we take this off we don't need
to do this resize now we're scaling and
then with the training we get back to
the training
um the screen we do not need to do this
augment because we've included this
already so all we need to do now is just
Shuffle put in some matches and do the
profession so that's it so we have this
okay we will now rerun this and see how
the training goes
we run this training as you can see we
have this very long trace and with all
this with this message right here which
isn't very readable so what we could do
is generally when you're trying to get
or understand an error and you don't
seem to have an idea of what's going on
you could run the model eagerly so you
use an eager mode so run eagerly equal
true and here you'll see when we run
this again you would have a shorter
error message or more readable error
message so you check this out and you
see you just have the shorter error
message it should be noted that
tensorflow operates in two main modes
that is the graph mode and the eager
mode so as you could see here when you
don't specify this you're running the
training in the graph mode the graph
mode is actually faster and more
efficient way of cleaning our model
whereas the eager mode is slower but
more easily debuggable so when you have
arrows like this you advise to running
this ego mode and when everything is
okay you could take this off or set this
simply to false but by default it's not
um it's not true so by default we are
not mode while doing this training
now that said let's scroll down and
check on our Arrow
and what it reads is we cannot batch
tensors with different ships in
component zero first element has the
shape and the element one had this other
shape so we try to we understand from
this uh that since we doing the
rescaling in the model that is in here
we're actually doing the rescale in the
resize number scaling in here we have
this uh batching that's what we had here
we had doing this batching on elements
which do not have exactly the same shape
and So to avoid this we'll just fix this
batch size to be equal one so we'll work
with batches of one and yeah well
batches of one we run that and we run
our model again
we run this
and that's fine so you'll notice that
the training starts and everything now
works well those gonna be slower since
we're no more working with batches of 32
but now batches of one and also to
ensure that this goes even faster let's
take this off so let's pause this and
then let's restart training with the
graph mode so we run this and run this
and this should now be faster than what
we had previously now training is going
on we could pause with the training and
see how it's going to be very easy now
with this model to run inference to test
this we've had this cell here the cell
image which will run inference on so we
have the cell image and then we'll make
use of open CV to read this image so
here we have our image uh equal CV2 M
read em read this image so
and yeah you could start by printing out
image so you would have that
not defined let's import CV2
um right here okay so we go ahead and
import CV2 we can close this and we
could import that just here so we import
CV2 that's opencv we run that
and then
we now rerun the cell opencv actually
stands for open computer vision so this
is a very popular image processing
Library which normally you cannot do
image processing or open or computer
vision today without really working with
this so that's how with opencv you could
read an image so image read and then
here we go you have the let's print out
the shape so you see that it matches up
with what we expect we have that okay so
here's the shape of our image and now we
are ready to let's add a batch so here
we're gonna have image equal
CF dot expand dims and then we have the
image and then we uh specify the zeroed
access so we want to add the batch
Dimension and then we print out this
image so here we have our image
okay that's fine let's print out the
shape so we should we should see that
okay we have this year and now you see
that we're gonna pass this into our
model directly so here we're just gonna
do uh Lunette model dot predicts
image
and uh that's it so all you need to do
is just do this you don't need to divide
by 255 you don't need to resize and the
model is going to understand now note
that we are passing this image of this
input which is 265 by 262 by 3 and our
model is going to automatically resize
this because we've included resizing in
the model so let's run this now and see
what we get and that's fine so it tells
us that uh zero that is
it's parasitic but which is actually
wrong but this is normal because we have
not really trained the model for a long
period of time and clearly from here our
results show that we should expect very
poor results why is this disturbing
let's scroll down Okay so let's scroll
this way and then scroll back up okay so
you see that here we have the support
accuracy 48 if we train for longer we
can get to the 99 wish we had already so
but this is actually done to show how
easy it's gonna be for you to run
inference on this model anytime you want
to in every in in any environment you
find yourself
so far we've seen two methods of
creating of implementing data
augmentation with tensorflow within the
TF image and then we've seen the TF
Keras now with the TF Keras is actually
interesting
when you're on your pre-processing that
is say resizing rescaling and the
documentation to be in the form of
layers and with the TF images
more flexible to work with now we're
going to look at a way in which we could
build a custom Keras layer based on the
TF image operations so recall that when
we're working with a TF image we had
this road 90 degrees
which was right here
and when we wanted to work with those
layers we had to play around with this
to give us that same road 90 degrees
effect
now what we'll do is in order to create
a layer which takes uh to create this
route 90 degrees Keras layer
and not just use this random rotation
because it's not exactly this we are
going to
define a class which inherits from Keras
layers so right here we have this class
which we'll call rot 90. let's call that
route 90 and then it inherits from layer
we have our init
there we go
self
super
there we go that init
and that's fine so yeah we we have this
um around 90 which in here is from layer
and then we'll Define the call method so
we'll Define uh the operation which is
going to be carried out in this route 90
layer which we're about to create yeah
we have self and then we have the input
image so what we simply want to do here
is we want to have or want to return the
TF the image the rod 90 so we're
carrying out the same operation but now
we converted this into a layer so here
we take that and then we have image so
that's what we output now
and that sounds fine so yeah we've had
this route 90 which we've created we run
this and then instead of this random
rotation
we are going to use this Rod 90. so here
we have around 90. take this off
not as fast
and that's it so that's it we have our
90 now and we are not long we are no
longer using the
the random
rotation layer so that's it we get back
and then run the cells and get to
training
as you can see everything just works
fine and we'll see how to get the best
of both worlds
as now we have the flexibility of TF
image and the speed and portability of
Keras layers before we move ahead there
is this point which needs to be
clarified so we've already seen that
when we have a single sample like this
one we did augmentation we're able to
produce different samples in this case
we have the rotated version of this in
this case we have another version in
which we've modified the saturation and
this we have this version where we've
flipped this horizontally
that said in practice we are not going
to feed or we are not going to create
let's say
um these three other extra samples what
we do is
if we suppose we want to implement three
augmentation strategies that's rotation
saturation and flipping for example then
for one ebook let's have this here for
one ebook we may decide that we do not
want to carry a rotation and then from
here we may decide to adjust its
saturation so let's have from uh this we
have its saturation adjust that and then
in the last step we'll decide that we do
not want to flip so at the end uh we
have this input and then we have this as
our output now in another ebook you
would have this instead you you may
decide that you want to rotate so you
may decide that you want to have
something like this let's rotate this by
90 degrees
um again here this is random so we
randomly rotating this
um we decide at random where I want to
rotate this at 90 degrees or not and
then once we have this we may decide
that we do not want to adjust the
saturation and then finally here we have
um flipping so let's flip this
um there we go we flip this and we have
this is output so in this case this is
what we pass in the model in another
case we may decide that we still want to
rotate so we decide I want to have this
rotation
um then
um still no saturation
but here we may want
um to maintain this so we may still have
this you see now I would not flip this
and this is instead of what this example
or this model sees now in another case
we may we may have the input itself
that's this input
um it gets past this no rotation gets
past this no saturation gets past this
no flipping and this is what the model
sees so
we can see that the model has now seen
four different examples of this same
input without us necessarily having to
create this four different examples
separately before starting to train and
so this helps us carry out the data
augmentation much more efficiently that
said when we get back to the code you
see that that's what we actually did
um yeah we decided to or we may rotate
or not we may flip this or not and if we
are to flip it's going to be
horizontally and then here we may modify
the contrast or not so these are all
augmentations which are randomly carried
out during training now for the other
alternative which is the tensorflow
image we need to make sure that this
rotation here is carried out in a way
that sometimes we have the image rotated
and some other times the image remains
intact now get into documentation you'll
see here we have
um this road 90 which takes in the image
and this key right here now this key is
simply a scalar integer tensor and the
number and it's actually the number of
times the images the image of the images
are rotated by 90 degrees and so here
we're going to Define this K which is a
random number which could either be a
zero or a one and that's it for this
rotation now getting back to
documentation you could check the same
for the adjust
um saturation
um Yes actually stateless random
saturation so you click on this as usual
we pass in the image and then we have
this low on upper bounds which are those
of the random saturation Factor so let's
um take this here it's basically
this
we copy this out here so instead of this
we would have this well let's just let's
just put this out here
um we have image
which is equal this okay so we're taking
the image and then we could have
um let's say
0.3 and then 0.5 okay so that's it we're
gonna
um have this and then now for the
flipping left right we get back again
here here you have random flip left
right then we copy this out see so we're
gonna randomly decide whether we're
gonna flip the image or not let's paste
this out here
um instead of this we have this now
there we go take this off
and that's it so now we have this um
augment method which randomly selects
which um augmentation strategies we are
going to use for a given instance and
this permits Us carry out augmentation
much more efficiently now let's do the
same here let's copy this
um and paste out right here so here we
have this
hello everyone and welcome to this new
session in which we'll treat mixed
sample data augmentation previously we
saw how to do the augmentation on a
single image like this or this one and
now we'll learn how to create new
samples based on a combination of
mixture of different images or different
samples from our data set and more
specifically we'll treat the mix up the
documentation strategy where we'll pick
two samples from the data set we're
gonna mix up the samples and then we're
gonna include this strategy in our TF
data pipeline up to this point we've
implemented data augmentation strategies
which involve modifying input samples
like this one so we could take this
input sample we could do a zoom we could
do a center crop we could rotate we
could translate and do many other stuff
with this in order to
our commands are already existing
theater
now in this section we'll look at
another data augmentation strategy which
is known as mix up now
mix up doesn't only involve just one
sample as we had seen previously with
mix up
we are gonna make use of this two
samples instead of just one mix them up
and then use this output sample and if
you look very carefully here you'll
notice that this image contains this one
you could see here you could see it
carved how those
dark capped out like this you see it
here and then this other dock right here
so we also have this one which is also
capped out like this so we could see the
mixture of this tool to form one input
so we have this output image which you
could Define as X Prime which is a
mixture or a combination of this image
X1 and X2 so yeah let's have X1 and X2
but this actually happens to be a
weighted addition that is we have a
certain Factor Lambda which is
uh a value between 0 and 1 and drawn
from the beta distribution
such that we have X Prime equal Lambda
times X1 plus 1 minus Lambda times X2
this means if Lambda equals 0.5 then
we'll have 0.5 x 1 plus 0.5 x 2. Lambda
equals 0.3 for example we have 0.3 X1
plus 0.7 X2 so some sort of weighted
addition now we've created this new
input it's logical that we need to
modify the levels because this doesn't
belong to either or you cannot really
say that this belongs to this class or
this class it actually is a mixture of
both classes so unlike previously when
we do data augmentation on this image we
are going to maintain the level because
it Still Remains this particular class
but when we mix classes up together our
images from two different classes
together like this we need to modify the
level and so that said we have a new
level y Prime equal Lambda and you
guessed that right y1 plus 1 minus
Lambda Y2
and from here we could now dive into the
code and implement this mix up the
documentation strategy recall we said
that Lambda was to be drawn from a beta
distribution but if you come to the
documentation we've been using so far
where we have this
tensorflow.org API docs you wouldn't
really find this beta distribution so
you're advised to look out in this one
year so go to tensorflow.org slash
probability instead it's here you would
find this distribution so here we have
this
um tensorflow probabilities
and then you have tensorflow
distributions when you click here you
could find many probability
distributions including this beta
distribution which we want to work on
now now just right here you could see
the beta distribution you have the
definition and then notice how we have
this two parameters which we must pass
so the beta distribution is defined over
zero one this interval 0 1 using
parameters concentration one AKA Alpha
and concentration zero eka beta so we
have the parameters Alpha and beta to
pass right here
now if you look up in this mix our paper
you'd see that the parameters are for
the use like here from this experiments
is um 0.2 and then sometimes you use
0.42 but most times they tested on 0.2
so it's this parameter we'll be using
and then getting back here
all we need to do now is copy this out
so we copy this get back to our code and
then we have
the mix up down here so here we have
this mix up
okay mix of the augmentation let's
reduce this and then we reduce this part
so or you wouldn't run the cells because
we're not going to make use of this now
so here we have this mix up let's test
out this
we run it
and we have this error name
concentration is not defined anyway we
could get back here and then import
tensorflow probability so let's import
tensorflow probability
and then put that as tfb we run that and
then get back to our mix up
okay so here we have this mix up let's
take this off
and let's take all this off actually 0.2
0.2 okay so we got that from the paper
that's understood and then we have
Lambda so here we have Lambda if we
spell it this way we'll have the keyword
the python keyword so let's just keep
that simple and just have the slam the
spelled auto spell wrongly and now we'll
do Lambda Plus in our Lambda
lambda.sample so we take we got one
sample from that beta distribution and
we run that and here's what we get so
you see if you run this again you'd
obviously get different uh outputs and
all this drawn from the beta
distribution and and the range zero one
so here I'm just gonna do this take out
this zeroed item and then we have this
output we could also put this numpy
to get it
see you have this now so you're not
having the tensor
but anyway we prefer to use it as a
tensor and we'll explain why will it's
preferable to work with tensors in the
function we're trying to build
from here we just simply apply the
formula so we'll have
the output image which is equal Lambda
times the image 1
plus 1 minus Lambda
times the image 2. so that's it for the
image we repeat the same process for the
labeling then using opencv we'll test
this on this two images which we've
added here we have this dog and this cat
image right here so we have this two
you're gonna test this on it
let's take this off
um right here we have we're gonna read
the images so we have image one
we're gonna do the reading in read
and then we'll do the same for M2 so
right yeah we could print out image the
shape
and level that shape all right let's
let's just print out the level so we
have that
we get in this error
um let's get Back Up
and recorrect this so This actually
Lambda let's modify Lambda Lambda equal
this so let's have that out okay so we
have that right we run this again
and required was broadcast broadcastable
shapes
which happens because we haven't yet
resized this because here we have image
if you print out the shape of image one
and uh image two before doing this
operation you'll see there are two
different shapes so we have to ensure
that they are both the same you see
they're two different now let's resize
this with CV2 resize
resize and then we'll specify uh the
shape so let's have your imp size
in size M size
okay we have that done we just copy this
out
paste out here
we have in size and then CV2 resize
Okay so we've all right we've resized
and that should be fine now run that
again
is not defined let's have that to be
defined here
um we actually defined this previously
but we haven't run those previous cells
since we restarted The Notebook so
that's why it isn't recognizing the IM
size
okay now level one I'll Define this
looks great already for this levels
let's say we have level one
so here we have level one equals zero
and then level two equal one so we have
just just two levels
okay
we run that again
and this is what we get you see we have
this output image and then we have this
final level and which happens to be
neither zero nor one
from here we could plot this out the LTM
show and then we pass in the image and
normalize this we run that and this is
what we get so you see we have a mix up
of these two images now that we have
succeeded to do this let's
make this part of our tensorflow
pipeline so we could take all this out
now and then Define this mix up method
we have this level okay we'll take this
off okay we we're gonna Define this
method let's call it mix up and the way
this method works is we're gonna take in
our data so our train data set here we
have one and then train data set two so
we have this two data sets which contain
the same elements but which have been
shuffled so that we could have this kind
of mix up
then we can now make this data sets
available which will do the mix up on so
let's add some code take this up and
then here we have our first Trend data
set we have trained data set one which
is actually our Trend data set we have
built already
and so we're getting our Trend data set
right from here we've run this already
we get back uh be careful we are not
running this but we may make use of one
or two methods from this so we have that
and then we get back to this so here we
have trendy set we'll do some shuffling
we specify the buffer size
and then we also specify that we're
going to reshuffle after issued
iteration we just copy this and paste
out here to have our train data set too
now once we have this train data set two
we now have our train let's call this
mix data set or mixed data set okay we
have our mixed data set and then we make
use of the zip method and with the zip
we're gonna pass in the train data set
one and then the train data set to
now if you could remember we had an
arrow when we passed into images which
had two different shapes so we have to
ensure that we do some pre-processing
before doing the mix up so that said
after doing the shuffling we could do
the pre-processing so let's say
pre-process let's get back up where we
Define this pre-processing and we had
here okay so we had at this level of
data augmentation we had processing
although we had inserted this in our
augment
but it's practically just resize rescue
method here so we could run this that'll
be fine and then we just do resize
rescale so we wouldn't call that
processing again we just have resize
reskill as we've done already we do the
same mapping here we have resize and
reskill okay so now we Shuffle we resize
and rescale and then we have our data
which is now a combination of data set
one and data set two this year was
Garden from gifi.com now we have this
mixed data set formed We Run The Cell
that's fine and then in here let's take
this off we've run this already so we
have that and then yeah we're gonna take
in image one so image one and level one
level one we have that the the suppose
we have image two and then level two
let's close this up
okay so we have that and then we get
this from the train data set one
data set one
and the train data set to so that's how
we get this we have image one level one
image two level two the image one that
we had here we don't need this again we
have Lambda uh we get Lambda we get the
image we have the level and then we have
our output so we return image and level
so this is all about the mix up now we
run the cell and then
we create this other new cell here we
have this error uh should have this
and then we create this new cell right
here
then we paste this out from what we had
done already and then here we have our
mixed data set so we now have this mixed
data set we Shuffle again we do the
mapping with the augment layer we'll do
batching and prefetching
but since I augment is no more the
previous augment layer we had here we
have now the mix up so here we replace
that we mix up and that should be fine
we have the train we could do the same
for the validation we get an error uh
spelling error train data set let's get
back to this
train data set okay so here we have the
train data set we run that run this
again
we have here input y of more model
operation has Type in 64 that doesn't
match the type flow 32 of argument X so
this is where we're multiplying the
Lambda by the levels so clearly we have
the Lambda
which is a float and levels which are
ins so here we're just gonna cast this
so we have this casting
we specify the D type
float32
that's fine and then right here we do
same casting
specify the D type again
and that's it let's run this again
and see what we get you see it works
fine we have this warnings also note
that here we were trying to experiment
and change this so let's get back to
point two run that again
okay so now we have our training data as
you can see here we have the batch and
then the image and then the batch and
then the level so that's it we've now
created this data set
which happens to be a mixed data set
then from here we are going to prepare
our validation data set it's actually
the same as what we had already so you
could just simply run this previous cell
right here this uh selling this data
loading just simply run this
run this and it should be fine instead
of doing this augment layer we meant to
just do resize with scale we just have
to resize and rescale our validation
data we don't really need to shuffle we
could take that off we could take the
Perfection off and that's fine so we run
our validation and then check it out
here see we have a validation data now
the reason why we have this is because
we run this twice so let's re initialize
this right here uh let's get back to the
splits we create a trend data
and validation data okay let's run this
again here now everything should be fine
okay so you have that you have the batch
Dimension and that's good so we now get
back to training and make sure
everything is okay
we rerun this and everything is now fine
okay so we're now set to train our model
so we run our sequential API right here
we're on this we then compile our model
and then we could get ready to train the
model we have this poor results reason
being that the mix up the documentation
strategy isn't adapted to the deal set
we're working with even if the mix
update augmentation strategy we've just
applied wasn't very helpful for this
particular problem it's important to
note that this mix up strategy could be
used in many other problems and with
that we've come to the end of the
section thank you for getting up to this
point and see you next time
hello everyone and welcome to this new
session in which we're going to
implement the cat mix data augmentation
strategy with tensorflow 2. the cut
makes the documentation strategy though
based on the fact that we are combining
two different samples is different from
that of the mix up instead with a cut
mix determentation we are going to take
a random a patch from one of the samples
and attach to the other sample while
modifying the levels accordingly we've
looked at how to implement data
augmentation with tensorflow and also
how to implement more Advanced Data
augmentation strategies like the mix up
in the section we'll look at this cut
mix the documentation strategy
here if we suppose that we have these
two images image one and image two
we are going to randomly crop a part of
this image so just like you can see in
this output here the randomly cropped
the section from this image and then
attach that to this other image such
that what you have in the output is this
one with this patch so this is how this
cut makes data augmentation is
implemented
if we take this example where we have
this cut and this dog right here
we'll try to randomly crop apart from
this dog and then attach that pad at the
same position
on this cat image here
to do this cropping operation we get to
tensorflow image let's have this we have
distance flow image and then we have the
crop to bound and box so we click on
this
and then
we have this definition uh we see the
arguments we're passing the image and
then we're gonna see oh we're going to
specify the offset height offset weight
Target height and Target weight now
let's explain uh what all this means
if you have an image like this one just
as it's giving you the offset height is
a vertical coordinate of the top left
corner of the bounding box in the image
and so this means that
if we randomly select for example this
box right here it's supposed to be
randomly selected this box
and uh our offset height will be this
distance that is will our reference is
this top left corner and our offset
height will be this distance here
this distance and our offset width will
be this other distance
so that's how we we have this offset
height and offset width
and then the target height is a height
of the bounding box so here we have this
Burning boxes height and Target weight
the width of the bounding box
so once you provide this it will be able
to automatically crop out this Zone from
the image
so coming back to the code we are going
to add this other extra subplot let's
have this other subplot
um we have less business code first
could just copy this out we have this
and then we have the subplot third
position uh what we'll be doing here is
we're not going to be having this we're
going to have image let's call that
image three and then what we'll be doing
here is we'll be making use of this
method so we have this method and then
we'll specify this offset height offset
width uh Target height Target weight
let's suppose that our offset height is
um let's say 20. so here we have 20
uh 20 say 15 so we have 20 15 and then
let's suppose this target height is 100
and you're say
98 okay so we have this
um specified and then we we're now
passing the image the image we'll be
using is image two this image here and
that that will be it so here we take
this off and then we could simply show
this passes here and that's fine now we
could take this off
okay so we have this we can now plot
this out and see what we get
okay as you could see what we obtain
here is the correct
uh it's a cropping of this Zone as you
could see you see that we have uh
something around this we crop out this
Zone it's actually it takes more of this
so it's something like this
now you could we could modify this like
we could shift the height and the width
so we could actually maintain the height
but shift the width so that we could get
more of the dog so let's do just that we
shift the wheat um let's say we we take
a hundred to we run that and
here is what we get you see that we get
the the dog's face this time around
and basically this is how we crop out a
region from this image now once we've
done this cropping we want to create
another image which is made of only this
crop while the remaining zones are
actually left out now to do that we'll
make use of this other method
which is the pad to bounding box
so here we have this image path to bound
and box we'll copy it out and you'll see
how it works so here we have this image
path to Bound in box we're going to
create another plot so let's let's
increase this number of plots uh we have
four
and year four and year four and let's
place this out first so we have that
copy this
pieces out and then create this foot
plot so we have this foot plot and now
what we'll do is just copy this here
and paste it out
so yeah we we place this out and then
let's get back
and then while we pass in as image now
is this cropped image so let's let's
actually copy this let's say we have
this crop let's call it a crop
uh and then we have let's take this off
we have the crop
place it out okay so here we have the
crop and now we're gonna take in the
crop now so after let's look at this so
after we've oh we've had an arrow before
so uh let's
um do this so you could see it better
okay so actually what we're seeing here
is we have this
um pattern to be done and then we're
taking this image and then we want to
Pat it all like stamp it on another
image
which contains only zero pixels
so let's look at that
um we have that we have this pad we pass
in the crop we have the offset height
and width and then the target height has
to be given so here we're gonna put in
the image size
because we want this to be padded on an
image with this Dimensions so we have
the image size there now we could run
this and see what we get
we have this error let's modify that
quickly so okay so here we have this
taken off
and then we have 20 a hundred
a hundred okay so let's run that and we
should have something reasonable offset
weed again oh okay we should take this
off
okay so let's
look at this
and there we go as you could see we have
exactly what we expect you see that we
have this somehow the same image but
we've taken out only this crop so that's
what we we actually want we want to be
able to take only this crop and then
take this like this crop and then add it
with this image here so what we want to
do is we want to take this image now and
then add it with this image
so that we could be able to create our
data augmentation pipeline
now we could we could call this image4
so let's let's have this as image four
equal this year
stick this off
image four paste it out and then once we
paste it out we could now
um let's also do another subplot so we
keep on doing the subplots let's copy
this and paste it here
that's fine we take the crop
as we have the this all right we have
this image for
plus our initial image image one so
let's have that and then we put it out
okay we're getting this plot but it
isn't very clear so let's let's increase
that figure size let's add the figure
size here and that's it so we run that
again and then let's look at this now
clear
okay here's what we get so as you could
see here we have this patch like it
looks like something is working but
there is a problem as we have some sort
of mixture of this and the initial image
now this is logical scenes
when you do this addition for this uh
for this black region you just have only
the cut but for this region you still
have the part of this cat image so what
we need to do is we need to remove this
pad such that when you take this and add
to this It just fits in like a puzzle
then to crop out just this part from
this image we are going to use the same
process we've used for this dark image
right here simply copy out what we had
already here so we had this cropping
could copy this out and paste it out
here we're on that and here's what we
get so you see we have this crop again
now we'll take this crop and then
pad to bottom box as we have done here
previously so let's copy this and then
what do we have
we have the seventh and then we're gonna
pass in this crop cat so we're passing
the crop cat and that's it
but we'll print out this image so let's
call this image five and here we have
image five we run that
and this is exactly what we get now the
aim is for us to be able to take this
and subtract like take uh this and
subtract
this image from it
such that I will be left with
uh the full cat without this portion
without this portion this portion right
here
so that said if just here you do image
one minus this image five you will get
this answer
so as you could see you have this old
cat without this portion and this is
exactly what we want now that we have
this part we could add it up with what
we wanted to add initially here so we'll
add it out with this image four so here
we have Plus
image for
and we get the response
and there we go so we've completed this
process of
cutting out this portion from here and
then fitting on this image one
we now take off this uh other parts or
take this off
and there we go we now have the crop the
image for crop cut
image five and then our final image
we copy out this mix up code we had done
previously so we get back to this
you see that now we could easily
integrate this since we have image one
and image two we just left with the
levels let's just copy this out
cut that and then here we take this off
place it out
there we go
and we now have the output image we now
modify this variable name such that crop
is crop one so here we have crop one
instead of crop and then here we have
crop two
so everyone will meet crop uh crop cat
we have crop two here we have crop one
and then there's image tools maintained
is from here we have image two then the
image for we could turn this to pad one
so let's call this pad one
um yeah we have part one
but this is actually part two since
we're working with the image two so
let's call this pad 2 and crop two we
have the crop two then from this we have
crop one and here image one yeah we have
crop one and here we have this image
five we'll call it pad one
then coming right here image five image
five is pad one and then image four pad
two okay so we have that done now we
could focus on how to get this Bound in
boxes so yeah we just picked this
Browning box but how do we get this
bounding box to get an answer to this
question we are gonna make reference to
this formulas which we've given in the
paper right here we are told that our X
is drawn from the uniform distribution
which takes parameters zero and the
width and then r y is drawn from the
uniform distribution which takes
parameter zero and the height
now if you consider this image and say
this box randomly picked
then our RX is a center that is this
distance from this as based on this
origin actually so we have this vertical
distance to this Center
which is our Ry and then this horizontal
distance which are which is our RX so
that's how we obtain r y and RX we
should draw from the uniform
distribution
now to obtain RW and Rh
we have this formula right here RW
equals ww is the width of the image so
we have W Times the square root of 1
minus Lambda recall how we obtained
Lambda with a mix up
um data augmentation strategy so is this
exactly the same way we get Lambda so
here we have W times 1 square root of
one minus Lambda are H equal the H the
height of the image uh times square root
of one minus Lambda 2. now uh note that
when you multiply this two that is if
you take R W Times r h you would have
white the numerator right here
let's have this
um RW times r h gives you this numerator
and then
um if you multiply this two you would
have
w h
times the square root
of 1 minus Lambda
so if you multiply this times this it
gives you w h this times this square
root of 1 minus Lambda times the square
root of 1 minus Lambda
and you have the square root of 1 minus
Lambda
okay so this is equal r w
r h
now we'll see how they obtain this
formula you see here that since you have
RW RH you could divide here by w h
and divide here by w h
this goes away and we left with this
obviously if I have the square root of x
times the square root of x
then it is equal x since I'm having the
square root of x squared now the square
cancel the square root gives you X so in
this case our X1 minus Lambda so this is
equal 1 minus Lambda and that's how they
obtain this relationship right here
now that said we have Rh or we've taken
this off let's go one step back
we have Rh let's take this we have
sorry RW and then we have r h so this is
our RW the width and then here's our our
H the height
our height
but recall that what we have to pass
into the method which permits us cop out
the zone for example
is
actually this
chord points right here the top left
corner of this bounding box so we are
not going to use the center but instead
is top left corner now how do you get
the top left corner to to leave from the
center to the top left corner what we
need to take into consideration is the
fact that we we notice this width for
example now if we know this distance
and we we have this distance from this
to this point here we're supposed to the
center then we could obviously get this
distance here
we could get this distance
to obtain this distance we need to take
all this
minus just this portion
to obtain this portion right here
now to obtain this portion is easy
because we already know the width R A RW
so all we need to do is divide this by
two if we divide RW by 2 then we have
this distance and since we already have
this distance RX then we can obtain uh
the coordinate the x coordinate for this
point right here
now the next thing to do is to find our
H and we're going to use sorry we're
going to go to find r y and we're going
to use the same method we did to find
our X in the from base in the top left
corner for r y we know this distance
now do we know this distance yes we know
this distance because this is half of
the total height since we have found at
the center
now if we have this distance then we
could find this distance because this
distance plus this distance gives us
this distance and so to get this
distance we need to take this distance
minus this distance to obtain this
distance and if we have this distance
then we have the y coordinate of this
point right here
recall that the reason why we going
through all this is simply because the
methods offered by tensorflow consider
that the bounding box cuttings are given
based on the step love on this top left
corner right here
so now we Define this function box
which takes in the Lambda
takes in Lambda
and then what this does is
it makes use of this uniform
distribution to obtain RX Ry and then
makes use of Lambda to obtain rwrh now
getting back to our uniform distribution
we could copy this right here and then
put this in our code let's for now let's
keep the function aside let's just have
this so here we have our uniform
distribution
recall our lowest zero let's take this
back our low is zero and our
high is the width so we have here M size
and we have that okay so we've defined
this and then we have our W or rather RX
that's RX now we want to have our y
let's have it our X our y
and then we could simply copy this out
there we go we have this let's print
this out so we see what we get
putting out our X for example there we
go we have our X
inside is not defined we restarted The
Notebook so let's get back to
redefining this m size
we run out again and this time around
everything looks fine now we could draw
a sample from this distribution so let's
have sample we draw a single sample and
see what we get you see we have that we
could take this zero element
and there we go so now we're able to
draw a sample from our distribution we
could do the same for r y so here
basically we have this and then what we
want to do is to ensure that all this
coordinates
are integers so we could cast this
we cast that we have the D type equal in
32 that's fine
copy this out and paste it here okay so
we have that and then we cast this to
now we have rxry
um let's just do the sampling directly
so we've taken this and then we do the
sampling
right here
sample take a single sample
take zero elements and that's fine we do
the same here paste it out and
everything looks okay so here we could
now print out we could now print out our
X and our y
okay looks great we have now a random RX
and our y
run again so you could see the response
now we have to obtain in size times the
square root of 1 minus Lambda so we
suppose that we have Lambda
we actually going to use the same method
we had used previously so suppose here
we have our Lambda
and then uh right here it's obtain RW we
have the IM size
or TF mat square root of 1 minus
Lambda
okay one minus Lambda okay that's fine
now we have our H our height
RH same in size 1 minus Lambda that's
okay so now we have our H our RW and R H
are X and r y what we'll have to do is
to modify this RX so we'll have our x
equal
RX
minus the width divided by 2. now we
want to have a whole number so we have
that minus the width divided by two
but the width is a m size so we want to
have this m size there we go now if you
um
don't get why we're using this just get
back to this image to obtain this
distance that's to obtain this
coordinate this top left corner will
simply take this this stands to the
center minus the width divided by two
and we'll do the same for the height so
that's it now uh we're doing that we
have our x equal RX minus inside divided
by two we repeat the same
and then we have it
4y
now this is
um
actually this width divided by 2 the
width of the Box not the another width
of the whole image so we're making an
arrow here let's get back to this we
we're making use of this width actually
not the width of the whole image so
let's get back and we'll put this code
after this so because we're going to be
making use of this r agent are
W now we have here this is our
w
rwu
that's fine okay now yeah we're gonna
make use of our H so we have the RH
y
[Music]
okay so now we have our X and r y we
could now print this again and then also
print out our W and our h
we get in this error
um we told that in this competition
right here
the RW is meant to be an INT that was
passed as a float since after this
competition here we would have that as a
float now we could we could always print
out our w d type
let's run that and see what we get you
see we have a float so uh we'll modify
that and cast it to ensure that we have
an INT there we go we have D type equal
let's just copy this
t f instead two so we paste this out
here and paste it out this way
tf.cast and that's fine so now we expect
to have
um the expected response
and there we go you see we have our X we
have our y we have our W and we have our
h
when we run or we run the cell several
times you'll notice that you have some
negative values popping up from time to
time and this actually happens when for
example we could have our Center at this
level but our weight is so large that it
doesn't fit in the image so it goes in a
negative Direction and this kind of
situations are say in this kind of
situation
you could have our box going out of the
image and so we have to ensure that each
time we create in this box we limit it
to the image so this box now let's take
this off
this box now will be
this one and this other box right here
will be
this box
so we redraw this box but it wouldn't go
out of the image our aim is to ensure
that we take this pad off okay so that's
it we are now going to keep this values
programmatically by using the clip by
Value method so here we have TF clip by
value there we go we have that and then
once we pass this in we're going to
specify the range so we're making sure
that the value is always fall in this
range zero to the Imp size
so that's fine
pays it out and we have this clip by
value right here so that's it for our X
our Y and now after running you should
have only values fall in that range
after clipping what we have is
if we had say initially this box right
here
we now have this box
so this is what we get after clipping
of course we get the coordinates of the
top left corner but the width in this
particular case has changed in another
situation we could have this for example
if we have this in this case the height
changes because we don't or we no longer
have this height but now this new height
in uh a situation where we had a box
which was like this for example here
about the height and the width will have
to change and So based on on this new
modifications we have to ensure that we
actually pass the right width and the
right height
and so what we could do is make sure
that once we have the center and we
subtract the weight always subtract half
of the wheat and half of the height to
obtain this because we had the center we
had x minus the width divided by 2 to
obtain the x coordinate of this point
and then y minus the height divided by 2
to obtain the y coordinate of this point
now uh what we'll do is we'll obtain
this coordinate right here
but while implementing the clip function
and so this means that if we had a box
like normally centered in the image like
this and then we have this would obtain
this point top left corner and then
we'll obtain this point bottom right
corner
just by using X plus W divided by 2 and
Y plus W divided by 2. so this point is
uh of has coordinate X plus W divided by
2 and Y plus W divided by 2. and that
said after clipping would have just this
now but what's uh interesting about the
method of clipping after getting this is
that now we know exactly where this
bottom left is found or rather this
bottom right is found and if we know if
we have this cut in it and we have this
cut in it then we could recalculate the
width and the height to recalculate the
width and the height suffices to take
for example for the width we take this
uh points here the x-axis minus this x
axis right here or minus x axis at this
point because this point and this for
the X remain constant whereas for
the y-axis this point and this also
remain constant so that said all we need
to do now is to take this y
minus this y so often the height and
then this x minus this x to obtain the
width
So based on that we'll recopy this out
and paste so here we have X
bottom right
X bottom right and Y bottom right
all we need to do is to change this and
add a plus and here we add a plus we we
keep them by value so we always ensure
that it's found in the image then also
now to obtain this final RW
so our rwu now is equal our y bottom
right minus our r y
and then the r h will be equal our
y Instead This is actually X and here is
X class H that's W sorry so you have a y
b r minus r y okay so now we've
um modified the way we calculate this
based on the fact that the Box may be
out of the image
and that now it has some modifications
to be done on the width and the height
now the next
step we have to take is if this RW is
equal to zero
then we have to make sure that RW
becomes one
and then here we repeat the same process
if r h
equals zero
then RH
becomes one so that's it now we have our
X our y r w and Rh that said let's now
create our box method we have our box
method right here let's have that and
this is what we return
so we're returning this but note that
here we're taking the height the offset
height offset width Target height Target
weight
and so this means that what we have to
Output in this method right here has to
be r y
r x and then RH RW
so there we go we return that and
normally everything should be fine so we
have this box meta defined we run that
we get in this error we should pass in
our Lambda
um let's go down we have here Lambda
Okay so we've passed in Lambda and
that's fine
now next thing to do is get back to our
mix up and then
we like we did before with the slander
we actually could get this we we
personally in the Lambda so we could
take this off from here so we run this
again and then we'll Define this Lambda
creation just right here we have Lambda
let's go back okay we have Lambda and
then now we have the box so this box is
gonna produce this up which we need here
let's call it
um our y
in that other in the documentation r y r
h
r w equal box
of Lambda
so now we have box of Lambda and then we
have this outputs here now instead of
passing this we have our y r x r h and
RW let's take this off those boxes we
fixed initially
we have this
yeah we have our y
and RX
scroll down that's RX okay
uh now we repeat the same process here
we just simply copy this out
and paste here
paste it out now also we have r y r x
again so here r y r x let's take that
off okay so that's what we have now and
the mix up seems to be fine so we could
we could get back run this method and
then around our mix up method again
now as usual we're gonna
mix up these two data sets so it suffice
to run this and then for this one we are
gonna instead of using the mix up
so here we come in this pad and then we
have the map and cut mix so here we have
the cut mix method we run this and
everything should be fine
we get in this error let's check on how
we call this oh we call this mix up
still this should be cut mix
cut mix we run that
fine
let's get back to this here
and run it again
okay that looks fine train data set
everything looks fine now we'll try to
plot out some value so you see clearly
what this looks like let's create this
new code cell down here this is out and
we are going to show this image from our
training dealer and there we go we could
notice this patch you could run this
again
and this time around we even have a
bigger patch so that's it we've seen how
to come up with this data augmentation
strategy but yeah we had to do do with
the level so I think if we print out
this level
let's print out a level
yeah see we print out the level
we're just getting all zeros anyways
let's go ahead and implement this
section for the level
and to do that if you could recall this
formula
you have
um one minus Lambda equal this so this
means that Lambda is equal 1 minus
RW r h
divided by w h
and the reason why we need to do this
again is simply because the RH like at
this level where we had this
RH and RW modifications all those
clippings we have to ensure that when
creating the level that condition is
verified so let's get back let's check
on this formula Lambda equal 1 minus r h
rwu so here again we have Lambda
equal
RH
times r
w u
or rwrh anyway we have this rwrh then
divided by wh so here we have M size
in size times M size okay now this is
one minus all this then we apply the
same formula for the mix up we have
this Lambda okay we've got no alarm
there we now pass this uh we have level
one and level two okay so there we go we
have our cut mix and then let's get back
actually let's we'll have to
re-run this run our cut mix and then for
our training dealer would have to rerun
again so we have to
run this cells again
run this and then we create our Trend
data set
we're getting this Arrow meaning that
Lambda is of type float 64.
we get back to this and then
we do some casting to send this make
this flow 32. okay that said we run our
cut mix cut mix run
we we run this
there we go there's cut mix we run this
again
and this is fine now so we have our
train data set and I will go ahead and
visualize it
we have this double knowns right here so
it's it's preferable for us to actually
um rerun this from this point
okay so we run that from that point and
then
we get back to this we run this
well that's fine we can run this
and this should be okay now okay that's
fine now we have everything intact so
that's fine we can now visualize our
data
as you can see we have our patch and
then unlike before where we had add a
zero or one now we have values between
zero and one
as high levels so let's now
run this model
compiling and training after the train
is completed we obtain this results we
see here how this accuracy let's scroll
down here we have this accuracy which
doesn't really change much so we just
around this 46 48 and
uh high is this 50 so it's around this
45 to 50 percent range and the last two
doesn't really change much now this is
due to the fact that the model is
getting confused and the reason why this
model gets confused is because if you
have say this uninfected cell right here
and this process that I sell it's
actually this portion
which permits the model know that the
cell is parasitized and so when you come
and crop this part right here and then
attach it to this so here at this
position
the actual part of this prosthetized
cell image which makes this parasitized
isn't sticking into consideration and so
the model gets confused
as now it doesn't really know how to
differentiate between an uninfected and
parasitized cell again this cut makes
the documentation strategy isn't adapted
for our model though it could be applied
in many other problems we thank you for
getting around up to this point and see
you next time
hello everyone and welcome to this new
section in which we'll see how to
implement data augmentation using a
specialized the documentation Library
called augmentations we'll see how to
use augmentations with tensorflow and
also Pi torch which will permit us to
see how easy it is for us to integrate
augmentation with just any Library note
that this session was inspired by a
question posed by one of us feel free to
always ask questions as this will permit
us better this cost we shall be looking
at the augmentation tool which is a
specialized data augmentation Library
augmentation is a python library for
fast and flexible image augmentations it
efficiently implements a rich variety of
image transform operations that is
optimized for performance and those so
while providing a concise yet powerful
image augmentation interface for
different computer vision tasks
including object classification
segmentation and detection now we'll
look at why we need a dedicated Library
like augmentations you're in a
documentation they argue that if you do
this kind of usual the documentation
there are a host of libraries like
tensorflow which we've seen already
which do this kind of detragmentation
but then when carrying out the
documentation with different tags like
say object detection like in this case
uh let's take this example here which is
more illustrative you have this image as
input and this bounding boxes which will
permit you build a model for object
detection
but then if you were to do data
augmentation and that you want to
augment this data by applying cropping
like as you could see here notice how
this image right here has been cropped
like what we have now is something like
this part
or rather this part actually now notice
you have cropped out this whole image
and you left only with this I think it's
it goes right up so it should be
something like this
um yeah something like this okay so you
have you've cropped this image and it's
part of your documentation pipeline so
let's
um take this off end this off as we were
saying you crop this image and here's
what you get now the usual the
documentation methods of working with
the usual libraries what you have to do
is after doing the scrapping you would
have to manually
modify each and every bounding box you
find here you see this bounding boxes
right here oh this one's not taking into
consideration because it's not part of
this crop so you have to modify each and
every bounding box you find here this
red Brown and boxes right here and this
is because this mounting boxes uh got uh
they get the positions with respect to
this origin right here on this case
respect to this origin and so when you
do the scrapping obviously this
positions change now instead of doing
this manually augmentation permits you
to get this
re-structuring of this bounding boxes
automatically without having to manually
modify them
and apart from object detection another
very common use cases in image
segmentation we have this original image
which has been transformed into this one
and then uh the image has a mask so you
are trying to segment the different
parts of this image and so after you've
applied this rotation you now get
augmentation to apply the same rotation
in the outputs another reason why using
augmentation is advantageous is the fact
that it has this declarative definition
of the augmentation Pipeline and
provides a unified interface so
basically this is what it takes to build
our augmentation pipeline now notice how
with this we can also include this
probabilities so you see here
probability 0.3 and this probability 0.5
now stating that those brightness
contrast augmentation will get a
probability of 0.3 simply means that
you're gonna apply random brightness
contrast three times for every 10 images
you process and this means that if you
have a data set of let's say let's say
we have a data set of 10 a thousand
images we have this data set of 10 000
images then what our model will see uh
the probability of our model getting the
original images is in this case of P
equals 0.3 0.7 so we have a probability
uh it is most portable that we will get
7 000
out of this ten thousand
from the original data set which our
model sees and then we have 3000 which
is going to be augmented then you also
have this horizontal flip so you have
the 0.5 so this means that you could
pass in an image and then there is no
brightness contrast and there is no
horizontal flip same as you could pass
in an image and you have the random
brightness contrast and you don't have
this or you may not have this and you
have this uh you may not we've seen this
already or you may have this and have
this but with this random crop you'll
always have it because
here there's no probability specified
then also it's advantageous to make use
of augmentation because
it has been regularly tested as you can
see it is in battle tested use widely in
the industry deep learning research
machine learning competitions and open
source projects high performance
diversity of supported augmentations
extensibility and rigorous testing we
also have here this list of transforms
and they supported targets as you can
see
this list is broken up into two parts we
have the pixel level transforms and we
have the spatial level transformed
so if you want to get more information
for each and every one of those
transforms it suffices just to click on
this so you just you could say for
example let's pick
this sharpen right here click on the
sharpen and you have here the arguments
and the description
let's take another example from the
spatial level transforms here we could
take the vertical flip so click on this
vertical flip you see we have this float
probability of applying the transform
default 0.5 now note that if you're
dealing with a very large this set that
is if your initial data says very large
then you could use probabilities between
0.1 and 0.3 reason being that since your
data set is already large it doesn't
need data augmentation that much now if
you don't know what a small medium size
data set you could use probabilities
between 0.4 to 0.5 nonetheless you could
always pick whatever value depending on
how it affects your model performance
getting back to the code we're going to
make use of this example tensorflow data
augmentation pipeline build with
augmentations so here we have the
transforms
and then we have the augmentation
function
then data preprocessing and finally
integration with tensorflow data sets
now based on the kind of data set we're
dealing with we have to be very careful
in the data set augmentation strategies
we're going to be using so like yeah we
could use this random rotate because
rotation doesn't wipe off those sections
which contain information that permits
us differentiate between a parasitized
and an uninfected cell getting back to
our random Roots hit 90 you have here
this argument floats which is a
probability of applying this transform
default 0.5 so we could make use of this
random rotate right here then just below
we have other different rotations we
have the random rotate 90 apply which
rotates the image a certain number of
times we have the geometric rotate where
we can select the angle and which will
do the rotation then we have this uh
save rotate
would avoid this kind of um data
augmentation strategies like the
cropping because yeah you could crop out
information which permits us
differentiate between the
parasitized and uninfected souls you
also have this resize here which we're
using
um pre-processing our images
we have
the vertical flip and the horizontal
flip which we are going to use so here
we have horizontal and vertical flip
let's add that here we can also do just
a flip we also have this random grid
Shuffle which we could make use of this
randomly shuffles with cells in an image
meaning that if we have this kind of
image and then we've picked a grid size
of 3x3 we could break this up this way
you break this up and then you have this
three by three grid cell and then you
simply randomly Shuffle this position so
this one can end up here this ends up
here this ends up here and so on and so
forth you could also have this random
brightness contrast so with this one
we'll take this all
and then paste it right here random
brightness contrast the next one
let's take this sharpen so that's it
um you could use other data augmentation
strategies you want always make sure
that you
visualize the outputs to better
understand exactly what you're using now
Define our transforms we have our
transforms augmentation compose
and then we have this list which is made
of the different augmentations yeah we
just copy this out let's have this
copied but before this let's do a resize
so here we could have a DOT resize and
then we specify the image size and
that's it so we specify the image size
we're going for the horizontal and
vertical flip so let's copy this out
there we go
you have that horizontal vertical flip
for those random brightness contrast
we're going to use the default
parameters sharpen we're going to use
the default parameters and that's it we
now have our transforms so we could run
the cell
we get in this error and this is because
right here we have to have this so it's
augmentation this is going from
augmentation you run this again
we're getting some errors augmentation
has no attribute sharpened even when we
comment this one we will also get this
error augmentation has no attribute
random with Shuffle so we'll just come
in this tool and then run that again
okay that's fine that looks fine we can
also implement this augmentation one off
with this one off either the vertical
Flip or the horizontal flip so let's
take this out of this here and put it
right here we have one of horizontal
Flip or the vertical flip now we're
gonna have this here and then so we have
this list actually we're gonna create
this list and it's gonna be made of this
two Transformations which is a vertical
and the horizontal flip let's have this
here and close this okay so we have uh
defined that one off and then we could
also specify a probability so let's take
P equals 0.3 for example and there we go
this probability here actually defines
whether the one off will be applied or
not and so we have that we could run
this again and that's fine drawing
inspiration from this method given the
documentation we are going to create
this our own method Arc argument which
takes in an image
creates this dictionary fits this
information in the transforms which
we've created here
and then
normalizes the image so this is what we
do with this Arc album mint method
from here we could have our trained data
set
similar to what we've been doing already
but the difference is that instead of
this we have now processed better
getting back to your documentation in
this process data here we have let's
copy out this process data in this
process data
what we're actually doing let's add this
cell here and this process data we're
taking the image we're taking the label
we're taking the image size
and then the actually modify this image
and have this and then take this level
and pass it to the output since the
level remains unchanged now for this
image size we wouldn't need this so we
could take that off we're just taking
the image and the level size and then as
this input we pass in the image
uh the tensor out uh is going to be
updated time flow 32 the function is
going to be Arc album ends so album and
it's our function
and then we're gonna make use of this
tensorflow numpy function now get into
documentation we see a it wraps a python
function and uses it as a tensorflow
operation that said we could still work
in the graph mode even though we are
having this
python code right here and this is
because uh tensorflow is going to
convert everything that goes on here as
a tensorflow operation so we could run
this we have the process dealer that
looks fine we could run this tool and
then finally we have our train data set
so we run our trending the set
batch size is not defined we should have
run this here okay we run the cell and
then getting back we run this again you
should be fine now
okay so here we have train data set we
could look at that and that looks fine
we can quickly visualize our data set we
have the image the level and then we
have an element speak from all that is
set so now let's IM show this IM show IM
we run that
we get this error because we didn't own
batches of 32 so let's just pick one of
these elements let's run that now and
that should be fine okay so here's what
we obtained
now we could have many more plots so we
have this figure we Define the figure
size for Iron Range 132 one and a half
blood that subplot subplot 8 4 and then
I and then blah dot IM show
our image I okay we run that
and here's what we get
so we have this and now what we could do
is let's let's get this cut out
which we have here in the documentation
specify a number of holes maximum height
size maximum width size the field value
always apply false and the probability
so when we apply this you're gonna see
exactly uh or better understand all
these different arguments right here so
let's go ahead and apply cut out which
should be more visible as compared to
the other transformation like the
rotations that we did so here let's have
this year let's you see how easy it is
now to integrate any the documentation
strategy you have so here we have a
uh then is that a cut out
and then we take the default parameters
we have them cut out let's run that
again
and what we need to do because the train
data set has been modified so we need to
like get the initial Trend data set we
had after getting from your
let's get back down and then check this
out
okay so we have done the transform our
governments run this run this and now we
could visualize
okay yeah the cut out hasn't been
implemented that is obviously there's a
probability of 0.5 so it's possible that
we don't have cut out here now if you
look at this you see clearly that in
some parts of this let's increase the
size let's say 15.
okay as we're saying if you look at this
you'll notice that in some parts or in
some images we have this portions which
have incurred out so you could see for
example with this one you have this part
which is cut out and then getting back
to the documentation
we have your default number of holes
eight and we could copy all this out and
then modify it so you see how this could
change the kind of output we get because
here you see when there's cut out we
have one two three four five uh surely
you have the other holes or cut out
regions in the black spot so you can
identify them and then here you have one
two three four you see you even have
this looks like a cutout anyway that's
the idea you specify the number of cut
out or number of regions you want to cut
out you also specify the value is going
to take
so like in this case when you specify
zero it simply means you're gonna be
having this black spots here so let's
have that
um back here
okay so let's put this in here and then
you have number of holes so that you
could modify this and observe exactly
what goes on to increase the size of the
cutout region you could simply specify
uh the values here
and then you have the few value you have
this Boolean always apply and then you
have the probability so if you want to
always have cut out you could simply
send this probably into one and that's
how it works so we'll see how this works
we could go ahead and train our model
using this augmented data but for
training let's take out the cut out as
it was just meant to show you how this
works okay so let's
we run this again
run this and then we visualize
as you can see now there is no cut our
region so that's as expected that said
we move forward to training our model
again so we run the training process so
the other results we get after training
for several ebooks you'll notice that
the accuracy doesn't go up to 99 as it
used to be before and also with this
validation accuracy we even get better
results
the other result we get after training
for several ebooks notice how here the
accuracy doesn't get as high as it used
to be before so the accuracy we're
getting now is uh the highest value of
accuracy we get is like 94.5 percent and
the validation accuracy we get in here
it's about that like the highest we get
in here is like 94.48 and this is the
accuracy versus Epoch plot we now get
also after checking on augmentation's
GitHub page we found this solution to
this problems we're getting here where
we weren't able to make use of the cut
out all right I will be able to make use
of the sharpen and the random grid
Shuffle so yeah when we do this install
which you have here and then on command
the sections you should now have this
working
hello dear friends and welcome to this
new session in which we will be building
custom losses and metrics the first meta
we'll look at is building a custom loss
method without parameters the next width
parameters and finally we'll build a
custom loss class and then from here
we'll go on to build custom metric metal
with parameters custom metric method
without parameters and custom metric
classes most times when building models
and training them all you need to do is
to pick this loss function from one of
these losses available in the
documentation now in a case where you
have to build a loss function from
scratch or a custom loss function in
which defining the loss isn't as easy as
just specifying this last function name
right here so right now let's look at
how to build such custom loss functions
here we're gonna have this custom binary
custom let's call it custom BCE BCE
stands for binary cross entropy so we
have the custom BCE loss right here and
then we'll Define it just above this
cell now we have our custom BCE loss
there we go and yeah what we're gonna do
is we take our we Define this BCE
um object the binary cross entropy loss
object and
obviously here we have binary cross
entropy there we go so we've defined
this object of this class and then we
return this computation of the binary
cross entropy of the Y true and the Y
pred so here this y true is the actual
output levels and here's what the model
predicts you could understand this
better by taking a look at the
documentation where here you see the
Define this object and then in Computing
this binary cross entropy loss you see
specify this y true and Y plat right
here now this binary cross entropy could
take several Arguments for example from
logits levels modding the axis reduction
and the name so that's it we have this
custom binary cross entropy and uh just
here all we need to do is to specify
this name so let's take this off and
we're fine okay now we just run this we
run this binary because entropy we run
this
metrics not defined let's run the cell
run the cell and then finally run the
training we get this error this function
takes zero positional arguments but two
are given so we have to have this here y
true and Y predicted
okay we run that and run that we could
see here how does training process looks
similar to what we've had already when
we're dealing with the preconceived
binary cross entropy loss now that's set
let's suppose that we are going to pass
in a parameter here so we want to
parametrize the way in which we
calculate those binary cross entropy
that is we want to have this binary
cross entropy multiplied by a given
Factor let's say we want to multiply
this by a factor of say 0.5 in that case
we could have this here as a factor and
then we'll pass in this Factor right
here so we pass this in let's stop the
training and then we train to see how
that works
we run this year and run this
Factor not defined we could include this
Factor here we run it factors still not
defined and this brings us to the way in
which we Define models or rather Define
loss functions in which we have a given
parameter so right here we're going to
define a loss here a loss function and
then we pass in a y true y right so it's
going to be like similar to what we had
with the custom BCE without a factor we
have that and then in here we have this
BCE and then we return this right here
now notice how we take this two off so
we haven't just this factor and that's
what we're going to be passing here and
then here what we return is this last
method right here so we we Define those
custom binary cross entropy we return
this last method and this last method we
take in the Y true the Y Prime and we
carry out the computation as we had done
before but now not that we're
multiplying this by a given Factor so
here we could Define our Factor let's
have this factor and your Factor then
before this we'll Define this Factor
let's take this factor to be equal one
because knock is actually equal one but
supposing you are having a different
problem you may want to modify this
parameter As You Wish let's have this
Factor here that's fine now let's rerun
this and hopefully we should have no
error so that's it we have no error that
seems fine and then we will run our
training as you can see in the training
process continues normally and we could
now check out on another method of
building custom loss functions which is
that of actually building a class class
which inherits from the Keras loss class
so that said let's add this year and
then we have our class we'll call this
custom BCE and then We'll Inherit from
Keras losses
loss
okay so that's it now once we have this
right we have our init method and just
like we did here we're gonna pass in a
factor so let's have this Factor then we
inherit Matters from the parent class
there we go we have our custom BCE
custom b c e
and that's it okay so we have this right
and then we now go straight forward to
creating this Factor variable and take
this value factor and that's it for the
init method from here we're going to
define a call method where those
operations are going to be carried out
now here we have this call method and
then what we take in is y true and then
y press Okay so we've taken this we now
do exactly the same thing we did here
take we could copy this out and paste it
right here we have our BCE defined
operation carried out and here we have
self dot Factor
okay so uh everything looks fine we have
our custom BCE defined
invalid syntax there should be a dot
just right here we run that again that's
fine okay so we have that right and what
we do now is take this off so here we
have custom BCE which is this class
where I Define how we just defined right
here okay now we should also note that
you could pass in the factor here we
actually have to pass in the factor
that's it because we didn't we didn't uh
specify a default value so we have to
pass that now let's run this that's fine
and then we we run our training and make
sure everything works well we get in
this error the call takes two personal
arguments but three were given let's get
back to this and we see this error we
did not put in the South okay so that's
it and let's rerun this as you can see
the training went unsuccessfully now we
know how to build custom loss functions
with tensorflow we then move on to
building this custom metrics just
similar out to the way we deal with the
loss so here we have a custom metric
without a custom method so we take this
off and then just right here we have
custom metric let's add this and this we
paste this out here and have custom
accuracy we now get back to the
documentation turn to flow Keras and
then metrics so right here you would
have this accuracy which has been
defined here we go we have binary
accuracy so that's it we have the binary
accuracy we specify y true white red and
the threshold there we go we can paste
this out here this is the loss uh let's
go back up to this metric okay let's
paste it out here so now we have this
accuracy which takes in The whitetron
Wire thread so we just return
we'll basically return this we return
binary accuracy accuracy which takes in
y true and Y bread
okay so let's take this off and that
looks fine now we have our custom
accuracy custom accuracy we run this
as well we get to this compile custom
accuracy fine we can power model and we
train the model everything looks good
you could see here this custom accuracy
now let's suppose we had a factor we're
gonna use this same kind of approach we
had with the loss method so we just
simply copy this out and then right here
we have this base stat then we have our
custom metric right here here again we
have custom accuracy custom accuracy
we're taking a factor we have this uh
metric which changes to metric there we
go and then we simply have this so let's
just copy this out and paste right here
so here we have this here let's copy
this out okay so we have this and we now
multiply this by the factor so here
again we call on the metric method and
that's fine we run that we have this
custom accuracy uh okay we haven't
stopped this training yet so let's stop
this training that's fine we get back
here and run this looks good uh compiled
and training model wait so this takes
one positional argument but two a given
so let's get back to this and then
include this Factor run that and the
training looks fine we can see our
metric right here our next approach will
be the class based approach similar to
what we deal with the last so here we
have this custom loss class we'll build
a custom metric class let's add this and
add this code so we have that and then
we have our custom metric class this
class here is a sub class of the class
metric
we have our class metric and then just
right here we have custom
accuracy so we have this custom accuracy
and then yeah we will specify the name
let's have this name let's say we want
to put here a custom accuracy
okay and then we we pass the factor to
which by default we set to one so that's
it now we have custom accuracy we have
our Factor and then what we'll do is
Define this accuracy by calling on the
add weight method which comes with this
metric class right here so we have this
add weight and then we specify the name
which is the name we've passed we have
the initializer
equals zeros so that's it you'll notice
that this will look slightly different
from what we saw with the custom loss as
unlike with the Lost class which has
this call method yeah would instead use
three other different methods the first
we'll be looking at will be the update
State method we have update State then
next we will have result method and then
the reset method so we have this reset
right here the update State method here
premises update uh metric State the
result permits us to Output the metric
values and then the reset parameters
reset the metric States so we have here
reset States here we go we start with
those update State method in this update
State we're going to be assigning a
value to this accuracy variable so just
right here we have cellular accuracy we
assign a given value now the value we're
going to assign is exactly the same we
had here with this binary accuracy so
let's take this factor and then paste
out here we paste it here okay so this
is our solve the factor that's fine so
that's it we assign this value to this
uh accuracy variable this method tool
takes in the Y true the white bread and
then with the results we have a return
so here we have this return self not
accuracy that's it and then here for the
reset States reset States we are going
to reset the state at the end of each
Epoch so uh once we finish we want Epoch
we reset the state and then recompute or
re-update the state and then output this
result so here again we have self the
accuracy assign the value zero that's
fine let's run the cell we get this
Arrow because this is actually metrics
so let's take this off we have here
Matrix
run that again this should be fine okay
so we have our custom accuracy built we
now get into this here so let's take
this off now and specify our custom
accuracy then here we specify the name
but anyway we've gotten default value so
we could just pass it this way
let's run the cell and then we will
start the training again
we get this error of the state got an
unexpected keyword argument sample
weight now we get in this error because
here we didn't
um put the sample weight as one of our
arguments so here we should have the
sample weights
uh we're not going to be using that so
we'll just set it to noon let's run this
again fine we recompile
and then train our model
we get this other error the input y of
equal op has type float32 that doesn't
match uh type 64 of argument X so this
is actually an error which comes up
because right here when Computing this
binary accuracy
we have y true and Y pair of different
data types so let's print this out and
you could see that y true and then uh y
bread
we run this again
looks fine
uh we get down to this here this
compilation recall or when we want to
debug we could run eagerly so let's run
eagerly set that to true and that's fine
we run this again and try to understand
what's going on
so as you could see that's exactly what
we expected we have this uh in 64 so
this is an inch and this is a float 32
we have the Y true so let's we could
cast this year so let's cast this value
TF dot cast and then we'll specify the D
type to float32
floor 32 that's fine and then just here
we take this off okay so we run this
again
there we go we now compile and then
train we get this other Arrow kind of
assign value to variable custom accuracy
the variable shape and the assigned
value shape aren't compatible
we get back to this here and what we do
is we're going to print out this
output which we assign to the accuracy
here we Define this output
and then we simply take this out from
here
and have this as our output and now
we're gonna assign this output so since
we now have the output we could print it
out so we understand exactly what we're
assigning to the accuracy let's run this
cell that's fine
and then we get to this compile and
train the model
okay there we go so now we see exactly
what we're signing but you'll notice
that
instead of just assigning a single value
we're assign this list and this is the
reason why we're getting that error to
solve this problem
would also have to understand that this
output actually corresponds to whether
the model's prediction was correct or
not for each and every element of the
batch so when we have a one like this it
means the prediction was correct or the
model's position was correct and one and
so on and so forth so because we've
trained a model for quite a while you
see that for all this or for this
particular batch we have kind of like a
hundred percent
accuracy so instead of printing out 100
what a model gives out is this list now
let's look at this again
we see now that with this other batch we
have some zeros so out of 32 we've had
three zeros and hence uh accuracy in
this case is 90 for this batch
that said we have to figure out a way of
counting the total number of ones and
then dividing by the total or by this
length which in this case is 32 or by
the batch size which is 32 and then uh
multiplying by a hundred or we could
just let it like that so images of this
method uh count non-zero where yeah we
could count the number of non-zeros
values very easily by just calling it
and I'll be fine so let's copy this
year and then
um instead of having this output we'll
count the number of non-zeros
there we go we count that and now we
divide by the length of this output so
we'll divide by the length of the output
but this length is going to be
and ends so we're going to cast this so
get a float we have that and then D type
equals here flow 32. looks fine okay so
now we have that and then we could let's
take off this output and then we run
again
within compile and then train the model
we still get another error so what we'll
do is we're gonna just check in the
documentation and then here what do we
see we see that by default this is an
INT so here we could also cast this we
cast this into a float there we go we
have this output oh we don't really need
to cast that because we could specify
the data type so here we have the output
and then D type equal TF float 32 okay
so that's it uh hopefully this should be
okay now we check we compile the model
start the training and everything looks
okay now
um we could now stop this and then get
back
to graph mode so let's run again so that
we could Now train even faster and
that's it for the section we'll see how
to build custom glasses and metrics
thank you for getting up to this point
and see you next time
hello everyone and welcome to this new
session in which we'll see how to switch
between the ego mode and the graph mode
in tensorflow well first start by
understanding what these two modes mean
and also when to use either of them then
finally we'll see how to switch between
these modes by simply adding this TF
function the Creator right here so far
in those cars we've been building
methods like this one in the eager mode
that is we've been following a
pythonistic approach in creating this
methods apart from this ego mode others
eager way of manipulating data we also
have the graph mode
in the graph mode we have data which is
passed into this different nodes right
here now this notes are operations and
so when we pass in our data which could
be a tensor this data gets modified and
then passed to the next node and right
up to this output right here this means
that if we consider this line of code
where we have x equal y times Z
tensorflow is capable of converting this
into a graph with a single node where
this node will represent this
multiplication operation so here we have
this multiplication operation and then
we have the two inputs y and z
then our output X
let's drive this way we have y z uh the
multiplication operation then we have X
now this x oh this data we get can be
passed into two order operators or two
other operations so here we could have
addition and here we have subtraction
then we could combine this to finally
have say an addition operation and then
get the output now let us uh come out
with some code which will represent this
rest of our graph here we've had X and
then we could have for example R which
is equal
X
plus a certain constant
so X plus a constant let's call that
constant k
we have X plus a constant K let's just
see constant
so this addition we have here is
actually an addition to a fixed constant
and that's it so here we have R and then
we could Define s to be equal
y minus this same fixed constant
there we go we have S now we have S we
could get an output by adding up S and R
so let's call this output T we have t
which is equal
R plus s
now this addition here is different from
this one as this one takes in just one
input since this input is going to be
added to the constant and the
subtraction here takes in just one input
as this input is going to be subtracted
or the constant will be subtracted from
the input which in this case is meant to
be X actually let's take this off
this is X
because here you have after this
multiplication you have X and this is X
that gets in this and the same exact
goes this way so here is meant to be X
and that's it so here we have now s once
we get S we have S here this uh tensor s
and then here we have our tensor R now R
plus s gives us an output T so we see
that uh under the hood what tensorflow
is capable of doing is taking this
python code you write and convert it
into a graph like this one one advantage
of working with the graph mode is that
this now becomes partable or this code
now becomes portable since in a case
where you don't have the python
interpreter you have now this data
structure which could be used in any
environment hence making our code or
this method more portable another
Advantage is that since we now dealing
with this data structure it can be
broken up into several or separate
blocks hence making it easy for
parallelization leading to faster
computations on devices like gpus the
good news here is in order to convert
this method for example into this graph
all you need to do is to add this TF
function the Creator
and when once this is done when
tensorflow gets this block right here it
does what we call tracing during the
tracing process this graph right here is
generated and once generated each time
you'll be calling this method you now
have your inputs passed into this data
structure and your outputs generated
without you going through each and every
step in this method getting back to the
code all we need to do right here is to
include our tier function the Creator
and this automatically is turned to
graph mode that's fine
run this and then for this augment we
just add TF
function
and that's it so there we go now right
here in this route 90 class what we'll
do is at this level of this call that is
when we
Computing this route 90 we will have
this uh the Creator put out here so
that's it
that's fine we run the cell augmented
layers okay
then this augmented layer meta 2 we have
TF function
now note that uh previously we had seen
this resize for scale layers so let's
get back we have resize okay that's the
recital scale layers but if we were
calling instead this resize rescale
and that we had already put applied this
decorator right here then it would have
been needless putting this decorator
here so in fact what we're saying is if
you have a big function and you have
this function say let's say we have a
equal a function called to to small
function there we go and we return some
value
we have that let's say we return noon
okay so we have this function of this
method
is we have this method defined and then
we have the small uh function right here
then we could also let's define small
functions we have small function and
then we have returned whatever value
let's say none so what we're trying to
say is if you have this decorator this
TF function the Creator put out here
it's needless having it uh in this small
function because once you put this then
all the methods which will be called in
this method will automatically be
converted to graph mode so that's how
this works we take this off let's
explore another interesting effect of
working with the graph mode so right
here we have print uh let's say I was
here
okay and then what we're doing here is
we're going to call this method we're
going to call this resize method
um the first time we have resize reskill
we pass in the original image original
image and the level which we got from
here
so that's it we
run this and we see we have this I was
here now we repeat this several times so
let's have this and repeating this we
should expect to have this printed out
three times since we run this actually
three times let's run the cell and we
see that this is printed out only once
okay that's what we notice now let's
take off this TF function the Creator
and run this again
we see that this is printed twice and
the reason why we have this is because
in the graph mode what we have is a data
structure a graph data structure so we
have this graph
um we have this nodes which have been
linked to one another and so when we
write code input output so when we write
code like this and it's converted into
this graph format
the very first time we make a call on
this method we actually carrying out
tracing now tracing permits us to
convert this into this graph format and
then the next time we make this call
since in the graph mode we basically
start in this operations and the data
that's going to be passed in between
the operations we are going to focus on
only this portion of
this method right here so this print is
not going to be taken into consideration
for the second time and for any other
time
so that said we could uh run this for as
many times as we wish and we wouldn't
okay let's let's make let's take this
back to the graph mode so this is the
you go mode taking it back to the graph
mode you see is going to be printed only
once and then you could convert all the
methods we're using into the ego mode by
making use of this config run functions
eagerly function so here we have
tf.config dot run functions eagerly and
then we set this to true so we're saying
that we're going to run all these
functions now eagerly and then let's
copy this out so let's copy let's say we
take this three and then paste right
here you see once we run this now you
see it's printed out twice this will
tell you that even though we have this
TF function decorator right here all
those methods now are run eagerly we
could also set this to false so yeah
let's take this if we have this false we
run it and there we go you notice that
we have nothing printed out and this is
simply because the tracing has already
been done the next point we want to make
is in the case where you're working with
the graph mode then there is a
specialized print you could use so yeah
instead of using uh the print some sort
of the spring for the ego mode the usual
python print you could now use this
print which is
especially made for working in the graph
mode so here we have this uh print here
and you see that the output of this TF
print is different from that of the
print because now this TF print makes
this metal look like a normal method as
it goes through this print each and
every time let's comment this and have
this so you see how this is printed you
see it's printed only once whereas if
we're having the TF print is going to be
printed twice then from here always
ensure that if you're trying to work in
the graph mode
make sure all your operations are
tensorflow operations so if you are able
to resize for example with opencv
it's actually a good thing but you have
to make sure that that resizing or you
have to try as much as possible to have
that resizing done with tensorflow
operations and so instead of CV2 the
resize for example it's preferable to
use this image resize method and then in
order to keep everything in this
function right here based on tensorflow
we should avoid passing in Python
variables into this method right here so
you should make this method depend only
on tensorflow variables in conclusion
we've looked at the graph and eager mode
with tensorflow how to leave from the
eagle mode to graph mode and vice versa
thank you for getting right up to this
point and see you next time
hello everyone and welcome to this new
session in which we're gonna go under
the wood and understand exactly what
goes on when we call on this fit method
right here in fact we're going to be
training our own model without making
use of this fit method so yeah we're
going to have this custom Training Loop
which we're gonna build
as you could see here we have this
training block we have this validation
block and then we have this method which
we named neural learn and this method
which replaces the feed meta which we
used to get in tensorflow is not only a
great machine learning library because
it permits us build and deploy machine
learning models its greatness also comes
from the fact that it permisses built
these models and train them without
getting to know everything which is
going on under the wood so all you need
to do to train a tensorflow model is to
specify that model and then make use of
this fit method
while passing in your data set which is
made of the inputs and the output that
said in this section we'll see how to
create our own fit method that is we'll
go a step further in understanding how
tensorflow Works under the wood recall
that when you make use of this fit
method right here what goes on essential
is
tensorflow applies the gradient descent
method to update this weight theater
right here so all the status have been
updated
until the model converges recall that
for given inputs X1 X2 and outputs y1 Y2
Y3 our aim is to update this weight such
that when we pass in this inputs into
the model we get an output right here
which looks practically the same as this
outputs
and to know whether this uh model
outputs are the same or similar to this
actual outputs we apply or make use of a
loss function which computes the
difference between these two and
generally initially when you start
training the model that's when you start
updating these parameters there will be
a great difference between these two but
as you keep on updating these parameters
we notice that the loss starts dropping
and so once this loss drops until it
starts it converges
we then stop the training but recall
also that the way we update this weights
is such that we take the initial weight
minus the learning rate which is a
constant we Define times the partial
derivative of this loss now the loss
which we've seen here which will
understand that is the difference
between the models predictions and the
actual prediction so here we have this
partial derivative of the loss with
respect to the parameter or the weight
in question
and so if we want to update say the
stator double Prime to one would simply
use this same approach
now the way tensorflow computes this
partial derivative right here is by
automatic differentiation and so when
you have this model with the inputs
as these inputs are being passed into
the model in this forward pass right up
to the output
tensorflow records this gradients or
this partial derivatives
and this is done for each and every
parameter such that once we get the
output and we compute the loss we could
now get this whole partial derivative
right here that is the partial
derivative of the loss with respect to
each and every weight and then each and
every weight is being optimized or been
updated via this formula so in general
we can have tether whatever and then we
have uh let's say IG we could have I
comma J
equal
Teter
I comma J
minus linear rate times partial
derivative of the last respect to Theta
i j and so as we go through this forward
pass what tensorflow does is it keeps in
mind the tatters and your gradients
let's call this gradients the Tetter so
we have the Teter and the detector which
have been stored or which have been
recorded as we go through this model
that's in this forward pass that process
of recording this gradients
yeah as we pass in our inputs in the
model is similar to what we would have
with a tap recorder where here you just
need to speak in this mic the
information is recorded and then it
could be replayed later on
and so here as information has been
passed in this model this gradients have
been stored and they could be used in
the gradient descent algorithm later on
getting back to the code we'll now see
how to build a feed method
from scratch
so here we have this let's have
far Epoch in epochs you see that now
unlike here where we just needed to pass
in this number of epochs and tensorflow
does the job here you really need to
do much work on your own
okay so we have for Epoch in epochs what
we're gonna do here is
go through each and every batch of our
data set so we also have that's for each
ebook we are now going to go through
each and every batch so for x match y
match in train
data set
um let's have this simple so we have X
batch y batch in train data set what
we're gonna do now is
pass in this x batch into our model
and then
after getting the model output compare
that model up with the actual output and
obtain the loss
so here we have white bread which is
what the model outputs we have the model
um here we've defined the model already
so we're working with a sequential model
we had built previously here we go we
have this sequential model and then in
this model we're going to pass our X
batch
there we go we specify that we're
training so when training mode training
equal true okay so now we have white
bread and what we could do next is
compute the loss so here we have loss
equal loss function
which we're gonna Define loss function
which is going to take in our wipe red
and the models or and the actual y so we
can make use of this custom BCE right
here now this takes in the white true
white bread so we should ensure that we
have y true before white print and here
we have we should have y batch and then
white bread okay so let's take this off
and that's it so yeah we're gonna use
our custom BCE we could take this off
and then specify custom BCE
now we have our custom BCE we could go
ahead and update this model's weights
but in order to update our model's
weights we need those gradients
the way we get those gadgets is by
recording or taping these gradients as
we pass the input into the model to do
this this part of our code has been put
in a particular scope so here we have
width gradient or TF dot gradient
gradient tape as tape we are going to
have this let's have that we are going
to have this two lines of code now the
effect of doing this is we are recording
the gradients in this tape or in this
recorder we could say this as recorder
and now all the intermediate values of
tether and intermediate gradients have
been recorded and now could be used in
Computing this partial derivative right
here
that said we can now obtain the partial
derivatives so we have partial
derivatives equal the tip so this t or
rather equal the recorder because we
change that to recorder so equal this
recorder dot gradient of the loss with
respect to all the models trainable
weights and so this line of code here
represents this operation that is
Computing this partial derivative of the
loss with respect to each and every
weight
then we move on to optimize our model by
going through this stochastic gradient
descent or some other gradient descent
based Optimizer like the item Optimizer
which we've used so far
that said we get back up to this
compiler we have this Optimizer let's
take this from here copy that and then
what we do is we are going to add a cell
let's take this up we have our Optimizer
here so let's have this Optimizer that's
it our item Optimizer defined we run
that cell okay and then what we do now
is we have
Optimizer Optimizer dot apply gradients
so we use this apply gradients method in
order to
update the weights based on the gradient
descent algorithm in here we have zip of
gradient or rather the partial
derivatives so we are passing in the
partial derivatives and the model
trainable weights so recall we have some
untrainable weights actually so we have
this model trainable weights right here
and the derivatives Let's uh scroll okay
um let's have this here
this
this is linked so this part
is linked to this and then for this it's
the whole algorithm the whole gradient
descent based algorithm
which takes in this partial derivative
and the model trainable weights that's
the theaters
obviously while defining the optimizer
we already set the learning rate so
there we go
then from here we could print out our
loss values here we could print out the
loss
print off the loss okay so now we set we
can now run this and see how this works
let's not forget to specify the number
of ebooks so let's have number of ebooks
equals say three four stat let's have
this epochs
and then we run the cell
we told here that the model is not
defined so let's modify this and I have
uh Lynette Lunette model run that again
we get in this error where we told this
expects the shape why what we get is
this now the fact that we have this
means that we haven't yet resized our
training data so let's get back up and
then run this uh cells here for resizing
and there we go let's
run the cells okay we have that
and now it looks fine okay so we have uh
the cells run let's get back to our
custom Training Loop
okay so let's run this as we can see the
training goes on smoothly you have those
loss values which are drop in and we run
this actually for three ebooks so there
we go we have our last which is dropping
let's and then we could decide to print
this out after a given number of steps
so yeah we could add the step and enemy
rate enumerate there we go we could
check out our free Python cars on
neuraland.ai to understand this in case
you're new to all these keywords so
there we go we enemy rate we have step
and then what we're gonna do here is
we're gonna pin our loss values only
after a certain number of steps so given
that we have 689 steps that's if our
batch size is 32 we'll suppose that
after say 300 steps we're gonna print
this last out so here we're gonna have
if the step modulo 300 equals zero then
we'll do the so there we go we have this
print
and then for every EPO stat we're gonna
print out uh training styles for Epoch
number and then we format that so here
we have the ebook Okay let's rerun this
again
here's what we get now so we have this
training starts training starts training
starts and then we have this
intermediate loss values which have been
printed out now what if we include the
validation so here notice we finish like
we train the model and then after
training for one ebook we don't we then
get into validation so for X batch
Val y batch vowel in vowel data set
we'll simply copy this out so here we
have this here
let's paste it out here okay so here we
have the y-prad
and our loss vowel the solution model
the year training is set to false we
have training false we have y print
vowel and then we have y batch vowel
here's X batch vowel tool and then we
pin out the Lost vowel so yeah we have
validation loss
okay let's run the cell now
while training is going on we could
include the metric here we have this
metric
which is binary accuracy
binary accuracy
now while training is going on we could
deal with the metric so here for this or
for each batch we'll working with
we're gonna update the state we are
going to print out the result and then
we're gonna reset the states
so let's get back to this part and then
just after this that's for this
particular batch what we have here is we
have our metric dot update State and
then we pass in our y or our y batch
that's our y batch through Y and then
why pred so once we update this metric
we can now
print out this metric value out of this
for Loop so after each ebook we're going
to print out the metric value
and so here we have print of metric Dot
result
there we go print metric the results and
then we should have your
the accuracy is
there we go accuracy is that's it once
we once we print out the result we now
go ahead and reset States so we have
metric that we set States
and that should be good so we reset the
states and that's fine we could repeat
this exact same process for the
validation with the validation just in
your in this batch we are going to
repeat the same step so here we have the
metric let's paste it out here and then
yeah we're gonna have metric vowel
metric vowel we update the state you're
going to use y batch vowel
and wipe red vowel okay once we update
the state we now
do this same process here so we print
and then we reset the states let's have
this here print and then reset States
let's take that off okay so we have here
metric
Val and then metric vowel and that's it
let's define metric and Metric vowel
here we go we have metric and then we
have metric vowel
so that's it so here we see how to
recreate this feed method that we have
here now that we've seen this we see the
training is going out well we see the
training loss the validation loss and
that's it but the training loss we're
getting here is for the uh each and
every 300th batch so let's take this off
from here let's let's say we print this
out after that's after each Epoch so the
training loss will print it out after
each ebook and that's it this means that
we don't really need to have this again
let's take that off so we print out the
training loss and the accuracy they
should be good we now run this and
here's what we get you see we have the
train loss we have the train accuracy
validation accuracy we've changed this
to vowel accuracy and then we have the
validation loss then for apoc 2 we have
the same book three we have this for now
we're in the eager mode so obviously
this training process is going to be
slower as compared to if we're working
in the graph mode now what we're going
to do is we are going to pick out those
computation expensive units of this cell
right here now we know that this is
computational expensive because yeah we
have to pass in our input into the model
compare this output computer loss
um get the gradients optimize the model
update the metrics so we look at this as
one of those blocks and then we have the
sort of block let's scroll up uh we have
this let's take this off so here we have
this block and then we also have this
auto block now you'll notice that this
is what we call the training step and
then this is the validation step so what
we could simply do here is create this
two methods so we have train
let's call this
uh training block
we have the training block and then what
goes on this training block is we take
in an X so you have X batch and then y
batch
basically we just copying all this so
here we copy this let's cut that and
then we paste it right here okay so here
we have this training block and then
here instead of having this we just say
for each step we're gonna go pass
through the training block
pass through the training block we pass
in X batch
and why batch then we repeat the same
process for the validation here we have
this copied out and let's copy this okay
so here we have the validation block oh
let's say about block here we have the
vowel block which takes L match vowel
and Y batch vowel there we go we have
the string block validation block now
just here we could paste out let's
create our validation block
and then take X batch vowel
X bash file y batch vowel there we go we
place this out so for this
we have that
now since we compute this loss in the
training block we want to return
want to return this loss so we return
this loss
okay we have the last returned and then
just right in here we're gonna say loss
equal this so we call this loss and now
we could make use of it right here
and then we'll do same for the
validation block with the validation
block we take this here and then we
return our last vowel
now that sounds great we should now be
able to change this in our graph mode so
we have TF function that's all it takes
to convert this to graph mode TF
function
that's it so there we go we've converted
this to graph mode we can now run this
we get in this error let's check on
what's going on okay let's run this now
we thought on and then doesn't match any
outer indentation level uh okay yeah we
should put this to match up with this
width and that should be good let's make
sure we don't have the same Arrow here
so we have this four and that's it okay
so let's run again and obviously we
should have no problem now we could
retrain our model and we should get
faster training this time around but
still we get in this error last vowel
must be defined before the loop so we
get back to the code and what we could
do is comment this section which is for
the training because this works already
so let's comment the section and then
focus on the validation block the first
three Mac we have here is we've made an
error
of putting this for Loop in this valve
Block it's not actually a syntax error
but more of a design error so it's
better for us to have this valve Block
in this for Loop instead so that said
we're gonna cut out this from this VAR
block and then what we'll have here now
is for this so we have for X Y in the
vowel data set you see we're gonna pass
this in here and then have this valve
block so here we have this vowel block
now everything looks fine uh we should
have that and then let's now run the
cell again you now see how just
recreating that Arrow automatically
solves that issue and then we could go
ahead and uncomment the section and we
run our training while the training is
going on we are going to create this
method so this method basically we're
going to copy from this so here we
should add the cell we add the cell
and then we'll Define this method which
we'll call Trin
oh let's call it neural learn so we'll
call this method neural learn and our
neural and Method we are going to take
in a training data set so we have
trained data set and then our validation
data set we could also get in the model
so we have the model we could pass in
the number of ebooks um let's have that
here so it looks like the fit the model
fit which comes with tensorflow so here
we have the number of epochs and then
after the model we have the loss
function loss function uh metric Val
metric and that seems okay so here we
have that
we didn't have this call so yeah we just
have neural learn and then we pass the
model the net model we pass the loss
function
loss function we pass the metric we pass
the vowel metric
well metric we pass the train data set
we pass the vowel data set and then we
pass the number of ebooks so all we need
to do now is just run this and then our
training process is going to start
getting back to the training here you
see how this training loss you see we
have the training loss we have the
accuracy we have the validation loss and
we have the validation accuracy
let's stop this and then we could even
take off the cell
let's take off the cell okay and then we
have that cell off let's delete that
cell and then focus on this so now we
have our neural learn which takes in the
model so here uh as you could see we
have this Optimizer we have the metric
metric vowel epochs let's get back to
the optimize let's add the optimizer
here so we should have after this loss
function metric and then let's have
optimizer
Optimizer there we go now after the
metric here we have our optimizer
looks fine let's run this and this loss
function are defined so let's scroll up
and we have this custom BCE so let's
just put out the custom BCE right there
Custom Custom BCE we run that training
is now complete and here are the results
you get you now know how to create your
own custom Training loops and make them
run in graph mode thank you for getting
around up to this point and see you next
time
hello everyone and welcome to this other
amazing session in which we are going to
see how to integrate tensorbot callbacks
with tensorflow in the session we are
going to look at how to log in
information from our training process or
from our different experiments into
things about how to view model graphs
how to do hyper parameter tuning with
tensor mod how to view distributions
histograms Time series
how to lock image data like confusion
matrices RLC plots and finally how to do
profiling with tensorbot in one of our
previous sessions we saw the importance
of working with callbacks as the
parameters to modify certain key
information during the training process
and also store certain information and
do certain modifications during the
training that said we have this tensor
bot callback right here which we spoke
of last time but didn't really get into
and so in the session we are going to go
in depth and see how to make use of
tensorboard to visualize on a web
interface vital training information
you'll notice also that this tensor bug
callback is going to be used in a
similar way to the way we are done with
the previous callbacks so yeah we Define
the Callback and then just here you see
in this callbacks argument we pass in
the tensor about callback right here so
let's go ahead and copy this out we have
this we could just copy from here we've
copied this clipboard and then now we go
ahead and see how to pass this in our
training process so we see exactly how
it works
so yeah we open up this callbacks you
see the different callbacks we have
created previously and then now we're
going to include uh tensorbot callback
so just yeah let's add this text and add
the code so we paste this out
then let's take all this off and simply
go let's run the cell looks fine and now
let's move on to our training process
here we're gonna have the Callback so we
have the call Mac equal
tensorboard
call back
and then we're ready to clean our model
so let's check on this we are getting an
error unexpected keyword argument
callback oh okay I should have callbacks
they'll run that again
now why are models training you'll
notice that there is this Lux folder
which has been created and the reason
why other log support has been created
was because we actually specified that
in this tensor about callback uh call so
here we have this lockdown log directory
argument and we're going to start in
some information or some training
information and this is training
information that tells about will use to
display very important training
information on a web interface now you
could click open here and you'll see
that you have these two folders in the
Stream folder you see you have this
information content in the training data
which has been stored here and
information for the validation which has
been stored right here the next thing
we'll do is copy out this here this
command and then run it just below so
let's get to where we hand
visualizations like we reduce this one
and we have the visualizations here now
we're gonna have this we're gonna see
how we're gonna replace this
visualization with our tensorboard
visualizations so it pages are we have
tensor board log part tool logs then we
created this log diet
variable year which takes in our path so
let's get back and then instead of
putting our path directly we just have
actually this locked there so we have
the logar now before running this we are
going to add this code cell and then
load The Stance about
notebook extension so here we have load
extension tensor board we run this and
then you see already loaded we are
loaded this already anyway we have that
and then thanks about now so we run this
and then we should expect to have some
interface which contains all our log
theater no dashboard active for the
current is Set uh check out those
Killers what do we have anyway let's
let's do this let's check on this let's
have logs
locks run this again
okay and there we go we see now that we
have this um interface which pops up or
what we see here we have this logs we
have both train and validation you could
pick this out as you could take only the
training data you could see only train
dinner and then here you have those
Killers those Killers basically stores
all this information which we pass in
here like the loss and the metrics call
that we have defined this metrics here
so we we are going to get all this
Matrix information so unlike previously
where we had to manually do this step
and do this step for the loss and the
accuracy now this is done automatically
so let's run this and then we will
compare what we get here with what we
get from tensorboard you can see here we
have this loss and then we get back to
tensor bar we had this level of skillers
um let's let's reduce this accuracy
let's view the loss first so let's
reduce this okay we check out we have
this import loss now this is what we get
for the loss let's include the
validation so you see you have this
um plot right here
clicking on this you could also expand
so you see this is the plot we get now
what do you notice you notice that is
exactly the same as what we had here but
this time around we didn't have to write
any code all this information was
automatically locked in this file here
and thanks about took care of the rest
so that's how this works is really very
interesting
and it's the kind of tool you want to
master how to use because uh when
working on different machine learning
experiments you wouldn't want to always
have to lock all these values
um by hand or manually you want to have
this done automatically now one of the
interesting point is you have all the
metrics here you just have to select any
one so let's look at the accuracy which
we we've seen already we can check out
this let's click here okay so we look at
we see this accuracy and then let's
scroll down you see you could compare it
with what we have here see we have this
zip around the this should be the ninth
ebook or let's say 80 book anyway let's
come back and check here
um scroll up from here it's actually an
interface in this other interface so we
have this you see and this ninth Epoch
what do you see here you see notice on
this here you will have this name train
smooth ad value
um what do we have step nine step the
time and that's it okay so there we go
um we see how we could plot all this
automatically and then you could get at
any point so you could go through each
and every point and then get all the
exact values so that's how we look at
this let's reduce this we could take now
uh let's say a Precision so you could
see monitor position
you could also check out the number of
false negatives you see how this as you
keep on training number of false
negatives keep reducing and then the
false positives uh what do we have here
false positives that's loading
um when I was loading let's scroll down
and we have the loss we've seen this
loss already we have let's look at true
negatives
that's loading through positives
here's a plowing gap for the true
positives and the true negative and in
this section where we have this
evaluation evaluation evaluations
practically the validation
um metric and loss that we plotting
against the number of iterations so
that's what we have here it's just like
the validation accuracy versus
iterations if you take off the train you
see nothing really changes here but when
you do this you see all that goes so
that's a validation and we could monitor
this and observe that the highest
accuracy we have is 94.09 percent or no
it's 94.21 scroll down we have Precision
what's the highest position here is
93.6 no the value is 94.39 as of now
we've been able to lock this information
just from compiling our model so because
we passed our loss and the different
metrics we're able to lock the
information and visualize it on
tensorboard but there are other
possibilities that is it's also possible
for us to lock information manually
instead of just logging only this
information so what we could do is
log for example image editor we could
lock
um even this
different learning rates here so
um we are gonna lock or we can lock the
lender rate
values for each and every ebook
and this gives us that freedom to log in
just any kind of scalar or quantity we
want so here we have this metric we're
going to create a metric dire metric
directory
um this is going to be locks and then
here we have metrics then what we're
going to do now is
create this train writer because now we
are doing this like manually so we
create our train writer we have TF dot
summary
dot create file writer and then in here
we have our metric directory okay so
that's good we have our trainwriter
created uh based on this metric
directory which is going to be in the
logs so in this locks we're going to
create a matrix directory so that's it
we have our Train Rider we could run the
cell
then just in your we have width so uh
once we're done with this with
with train writer as default
we generator as default we want to have
this
um locked so we have TF the summary
that's killer
and then we specify that we're dealing
with the learning rate so our learning
rate and then we're going to pass in the
The Learning rate actually so your
personal learning rate and now we pass
in the epoch so this is like uh as you
could see here you have data look at
look at this pop-up you see here you
have data and then here you have steps
all right a step so you have the name of
this killer you have the data and you
have the step you also have the
description so here we have the name
um which is learning rate we have the
data which is this learning rate and
then we have the step which is the ebook
now we'll have to do this like with this
we have to
put it in each and every one of this
since either we get into this I'll get
into that but to avoid writing this
twice we just have to set we could set a
learning rate so in your
we Define this learning rate learning
rates
and then year two we have our learning
rate
there we go we have the learning rate
and then out of this we return our
learning rate
okay so that's it now we return the
learning rate and then we are also
logging this data so here we should
change this and have learning rate so
that's it now we have the set and then
we could go on and train
before training recall each time you
want to log in this kind of data all
this kind of custom data first thing you
do you create your writer as you create
this file writer after creating the file
writer based on a given directory that
you set you now go ahead and then put
this in this
trainwriter scope right here so with
this we can run this now we run this
already we can run this now and then
um since this is our schedule our
callback we'll have to add this in our
feet so let's go ahead and add it in
this outfit method here let's take now
just five ebooks so here we have tensor
but callback and then we have scheduler
call back okay so we run this now and
see what we get that's training
uh training is now complete let's go
ahead and check this year we have our
locks you see we have this metrics and
we have this locked
um next step we go to visualize so here
we have this tensor bar and then here
let's do anyway let's let's run this
first so you'd see what we get as you
could see right here we now have this
learning rate which has been logged and
which we can visualize so you see
um
as we go from this Epoch to this ebook
to this this if we set this at zero
smoothening we have this now the reason
why we after this we don't get any value
is because of what we have here so we
sent the linear into the center and what
we should be doing here is getting that
numpy so we should have
this learning rate right here learning
rate equal the learning rate because
this is going to be converted into a
tensor so we have learning rate that
numpy and that should be cool okay we
run this again and that should work and
then to to view or to have immediate
response let's set this to just one so
if the number of epochs greater than
greater than one then we would have the
learning rate being modified so let's
get back again to training this time
around Let's see we just have three
ebooks
okay this time around we have this uh
actual value locked and so we will get
back let's reduce this custom Training
Loop we get back to our visualizations
we will run this again
getting back here we see we start with
this loss and then this drops after this
second Epoch right here as you may have
noticed each and every time we run a new
training process the previous values are
the previous locked input data is being
deleted so what we could do now is we
modify this file name as this logs file
we're using here where
this folder name now depends on the
current time so yeah we're gonna have
date time
uh the time dot date time dot now and
then we get a string string from
the time
and then format this output so yeah
we're gonna have percentage the day
percentage the month the year and then
we specify the exact time so you're
gonna have the r
the minute and the second now let's go
ahead and import the time up here we
have
um date time
so yeah we import the time simply
um that should be imported okay so we
run that and that should be fine okay
we've imported date time let's get back
and then let's print out this log die
right here let's have log that I printed
out see what we get see we have this
logs and this is actually a new folder
now if you print if you print out this
again you see it we're gonna have a
different folder and this is important
because each and every time we do not
need to cancel our previous runs
from here let's stick I'll let's take
this off and then set this as our
current time so current time
current
time is equal this
um take this off here's our current time
and then we have
this Plus
current
time okay and then here we'll do the
same we have this plus current time
let's take this off and then have
the current time here
current
time
if we get back to this training we run
this again training now complete as we
could see here in this locks we have
this on your folder created which is
dependent on the time in which we
decided to do the training and then in
this metrics we also have this but what
we want to have is actually just this
one folder which contains a train
validation and the metrics so we should
modify this right up here
so instead of having this Matrix before
we should take this off
you should take this off and then add it
later on we have plus and then we add
this okay so we have this slash and then
slash then we should take this now so
that's it we have
um we created this and then we will run
again to avoid this kind of error so
let's go ahead and retrain our model
let's all right let's have that to be
yeah it's fine let's say two epochs and
I'll run that again okay the training is
complete now you'll see that if you open
this up you have train validation this
is what we had previously but now we
have metric strain validation this is
actually what we want we want to be able
to lock all this into this one directory
and you'll now notice how we do not have
to erase previous logs so let's go down
to running this again we run this take
this off
okay there we go we have this
information now locked you'll see we
could take all this previous locks out
and focus on just this log here so let's
have this one this should be zero five
the same um ends with seven one so we
want to focus on this one which ends
with seven one and uh okay here we go so
we have this Matrix The Strain and this
validation for this we are not
interested in logging this so that's it
let's take this off now and then get
back so you see here we have the
learning rate we have the epoch accuracy
we have this uh true negatives we have
the recall
and that's it so here we've seen now how
to create this directories which are
dependent on the current date and time
now the next step we'll be doing is how
to actually do this logs without or when
we're doing a custom Training so let's
get back to where we do this custom
Training Loop we have this custom
Training Loop and then we have this
um feed method which comes directly with
tensorflow so what if we now try to use
or what if we actually use the custom
Training Loop and we do not have the
possibility of just simply saying okay
callbacks tensor by callback and then
the job is done and what if we just have
this custom Training Loop in this case
we're going to use exactly the same
process we've just followed here so
we're just gonna create
this firewriter so let's copy all this
and then
um just as we did here actually we're
just gonna put uh right in this scalar
values and then like create this killer
put in the ditter and then specify the
step so that's basically how we're gonna
function now let's get back to this our
custom Training loop we're going to add
this code cell and then in here we have
current time as usual we have now let's
call this custom directory we have logs
current time and then we have custom
let's call this custom uh trainwriter
let's call this Custom trainwriter
Custom trainwriter and you could also
Define a custom validation writer
couldn't we could have that too so let's
have here
custom
custom direct and in here we will
specify also train so notice that since
you were using this fit what we got was
the uh automatically we automatically
got this train and validation so what
happens in the background is these two
file writers are created that is the
train and the validation and we're just
going to do exactly that year we have
custom and then let's say we have
um custom train directory custom train
and then custom validation okay so we
have that and then here we have custom
validation now we specify our writer we
have custom train and custom validation
then here we have custom train
custom train
custom validation okay so I think this
is okay we could now run this and then
um let's copy out this code we had put
out here in the section in the scheduler
so let's simply copy this out you see
how easy it becomes when you have
already done this so yeah you you now
have to say
instead of just only printing this out
you let's have this so with
our let's copy let's get the name from
here with our custom trainwriter and
then here we have with our custom
trainwriter
custom trainwriter we have the loss so
we have the loss let's call it training
loss we have the training loss we have
the ditter the dealer is now this last
year is this loss so we have the the
data which is passed which is now the
loss and then the step is the e-book we
have here so that's it okay we've locked
this let's now go ahead and lock for the
accuracy so we place this out and then
we have training accuracy
accuracy
and then the accuracy so we we kind of
base out we will see metric uh the
results
metric the results okay metric the
results and then we have the step
specified so this is for the training
process we could separate this block and
that's it Okay so we've done this we now
simply copy this out and then do the
same for the validation so in your
instead of writing this out like this we
could simply put out your custom file
uh we have custom valve take this off
here we have validation validation loss
here we have the loss well this is lost
vowel loss vowel that's fine we have
metric vowel metric vowel
that's fine we have validation accuracy
validation
validation accuracy now you have this
two take this off and then we have the
valve okay so that sounds fine
um everything looks okay we could run
this here so let's run this we run this
and then we run error learn and then we
start with the training
train now complete let's go ahead and
see what we have you could check out
this logs you see we have our values now
logged in here custom train and
validation so we have this locked we now
go ahead and
rerun this tensor board as you can see
you have all these values here you could
as usual let's take this off
um toggle our runs and then let's pick
this uh very last one so we pick this
last one and
also pick out this one because there's a
train and this is the validation then we
come right here and check out the
training accuracy uh train loss
there we go we have train accuracy we
have train loss
if we if we do this see we have okay we
have the train accuracy we have the
train loss we have the validation
accuracy and we have the validation loss
now if we want to take off all the
information start in the logs you could
have this command so we remove all this
information and then we specify the
locks so we run this and then opening up
this you see you don't have the unlocks
folder anymore at this point we'll go
ahead and see how the display image data
with tensor bot so unlike previously
where we've been displaying information
like the loss the different metrics now
we'll see how to implement or rather
we're going to display image data like
the confusion metrics we had seen
previously
um let's get back here we have this
conversion Matrix right here and what
we'll do now is after each ebook we are
gonna display this conversion Matrix uh
with tensorboard that set we're going to
copy out all this code we use in
displaying this conversion Matrix right
here so we have this code and then we
have this log images callback right here
with this on eBook and Method and then
in this method we are going to paste out
this code we used in visualizing the
confusion Matrix previously so here we
have this level input
um right after this we have the
completion metrics based on the
threshold and then we are going to
visualize this conversion Matrix but now
since we're working with a callback what
we're doing is at the end of each and
every ebook we are going to display this
with tensorboard now that this is set we
are going to uh for now we've actually
just been able to visualize this but how
do we put this or how do we make this
work with tensorbot what we're going to
have here is we create a buffer
we have this buffer
io.bytes IO here we have bytes IO and
then so that's our buffer we are going
to save this image the conversion Matrix
image in this buffer so we have this
plt.save feed and then we save it in
that buffer and then we'll specify that
the format
should be PNG
so we have the PNG format and that's
okay so now we have this buffer we've
saved that into our buffer
The Next Step we'll take is create an
image of this buffer so from here we
have this image let's take this up we
have this image we use the tensorflow
image uh decode PNG
method which takes in this buffer so we
have our buffer get value number of
channels equal three that's it we have
this image and then once we get this
image we then write this in tensorboard
so we have this image writer which we've
created right here similar to what we've
done already we create we use this
create file writer
let's modify this and have your image
directory so we have the image directory
and then we create this file writer
um all right I will create this image
writer so from with this image writer's
default what we're going to do now is
instead of having this uh summary Dot
scalar as we used to have here now we're
gonna use summary.image so you could see
here that tells about pyramids us not
only
um input or write scalars but also
images
and that's basically all we needed to do
here so let's have this and then run the
cell so we make sure we have this run
run this we run this and then we okay we
have this log images call back here copy
that now that's copied we have to reduce
this one and then right here we run this
Matrix and then compile and run this
we get this Arrow where we said oh well
we have this value error no step set so
let's get back to this uh call back and
then we specify the step so right here
we have the step step equal the epoch so
we run that again and this should be
fine trainers going on and then the
image theater has been logged into
tensor bot at the end of each Epoch
train now done we could go ahead and
then run this on tense about once
training down we could now visualize
this conversion matrices on tensorboard
so we run this to cells
and here's what we get you'd see your
Step Zero step one and then step two
this because we actually run this for
three epochs so we could notice how
let's come back to the top we notice how
here we have 53
and then as we keep training this drops
to 35 and then finally here let's scroll
down a little
finally here we have
240 so this tells us that the last Epoch
wasn't
helpful improving the number of files
negatives you could see also even with
the validation that uh yeah we had 16
false negatives eight false negatives
and then we this value rose up to 100
111 false negatives so it's
kind of similar to Huawei how the test
data
which is exactly why we're logging in
the tensor bar and now that you know how
to log in image data with sensorbot from
the example on the conversion Matrix
what you could do is log indirectly this
Roc plots you could also log in data
like
this one right here where on the test
theater you're gonna put out the actual
value and what the model predicts and so
that's it for the session on login and
image there now let's move on to
visualizing model graphs with
tensorboard to visualize the graph we're
going to rerun this command to delete
all the logs we've stored so far and
then we run this tell us about callback
once more so we have that and then let's
get back to metrics we run this and
that's fine
now we have the training done let's go
ahead and rerun this again so we run
this two cells again and as expected
here's what we get
so here we have this killers and then if
you click on those graphs here it would
have this graph coming up let's reduce
this slightly okay so we have this
notice that the graph type here is up
graph and this actually means we're
viewing the graph from the operations
level if you could uh come right here
and zoom in you'll see you have the conf
layer you have the conf layer again then
Slayer dance layer and then zoom in this
other way uh here you see you have the
albums Optimizer let's double click here
where you have this plus you double
click and then you get to see exactly
what goes on in this Adam Optimizer
let's reduce that zoom in and then let's
double click again to reduce this okay
so here we have that and for this dance
layer you could double click you see you
have that you see you have this candle
you double click to better understand
what goes on
and as you can see here we have this
regularizer so the regularizer we had
defined previously now let's reduce this
by double clicking let's scroll here we
double click that reduced and then
double click this so basically tanks the
tanks are bar we're able to visualize
exactly what goes on under the hood when
tensorflow creates this graphs which in
turn parameters do computations even
faster now another way we could look at
this is by coming right here the stack
and selecting class once we select this
Keras we instead of having the operation
graph we are just seeing we now have
this conceptual graph we'll see that
this is going to be quite easy compared
to or easy to understand compared to
what we had done previously so you have
this focuses on the Keras uh model we
have built a curious sequential model we
had specified and here what we have is
you see the input so unlike previously
where we had stuff like Adam Optimizer
the different metrics and the say loss
computations with the up graph here we
have just the Keras model so here you
have the input conf batch normalization
Max pulling drop out count batch
normalization Max pulling flatten dance
match Norm drop out Dance Bash norm and
finally dance so that's
um our conceptual graph
and that's it for the section on graphs
you see you get to understand exactly
what goes on under the hood thanks to
this uh visualization
or better sales graphs visualization
made available with tensorboard
now as we go ahead with building these
models and then training them you may
sometimes wonder why this value 6 for
example was picked why the the kennel
size 3 was peaked maybe why the 16 was
picked here why 100 would speak why not
say 32 why not say a value like 100 Year
why others values were picked and then
looking at the drop hour rate what makes
a speaker given dropout rate what makes
us bigger given regularization rate and
so on and so forth
now although in this particular case
we're building this model based on the
Lynette model which is some like a model
which has already been built and tested
we'll see another technique known as the
hype parameter tuning where we'll be
able to select the best values for this
different hyper parameters automatically
now this hyper parameters must not be
only this which we've picked out here we
could also have hyper parameters like
the learning rate like even the choice
of this Optimizer and so on and so forth
and this way of deciding this best
parameters for our model and model
training is known as Hyper parameter
tuning now we're gonna see how to do or
carry out hyper parameter tuning with
tensor board so yeah first in first we
carry out those Imports we have from
tensorboard plugins HP params hyper
parameters we're going to import API as
HP then right here we are going to
redefine this model or we're going to
restructure it so instead of having just
the regularization array drop our rate
given to us like this what we're gonna
have here is here for example instead of
having this drop hour rate we'll have HP
Rams and then we'll have HP
drop out and the aim of this process is
to ensure that if we have this suppose
we have this model here and then after
training we have an outputted accuracy
we want to be able to modify the
parameters which make up this model and
see how they affect the accuracy such
that we are going to pick out the best
parameters or we're going to pick out
the parameters which parameters get the
best possible accuracy so that said
um instead of having the drop out we
just have this uh variable drop out and
then for the regularization we're gonna
do same so you're gonna have H perams
instead of regularization rate we're
going to have
um this and then we have HP
regularization rate then apart from this
um regularization rate and drop out
hyper parameters we're gonna include uh
just right here let's start with this
one so let's copy be out this we have HP
Rams and then we have HP number of units
so here we have number of units and then
we call this one because
um just after this we're gonna have
number of units two so here we are gonna
be able to pick out the best possible
values for this hyper parameter here so
let's have this here too okay so that's
it the other hyper parameters will be
included when doing the model
compilation so let's include this model
compilation and then we're gonna carry
out the training in here so we have this
let's take out the summary and then take
this back okay so that's it now we have
this model completion right here and
then we have the optimizer but what
we're gonna do here is we're gonna fix
this Optimizer so we're gonna have the
item Optimizer and then we'll specify
the learning rate to be ish params and
then we have your HP learning reads
learning rate okay so there we go this
looks fine we have the last Banner cross
entropy Matrix accuracy and then we do
the model training so once we do this
model training we are gonna
um get the accuracy that we're gonna
train the model we're gonna evaluate the
model we obtain the accuracy and then 10
survive with parameters modify all these
different parameters such that we now
get the parameters or the specific
values which parameters maximize this
accuracy so here we're gonna create a
function
which is going to return the accuracy
let's have this to the right and that's
it we have this method which we'll call
model tune called Model tune and then
it's going to take HP Rams so it's going
to take this HP Rams and then it's gonna
like take different value for HP Rams
and then based on the accuracy we're
gonna know after this different training
steps which values for this hyper
parameters best uh gives us the best
results so that's it we have that and
then we return the accuracy right here
then we're gonna Define the range of
values this different hyper parameters
can take so like this one let's copy
this out let's say we want to get this
HP number of units one pieces out here
we're gonna have HP Dot
HP Rams there we go and then we have
the name specified so we have number of
units one
and we also specify now this range so we
have HP that discrete so let's have
discrete and then let's say we want to
pick out those values between the range
um say 10 to 100. now let's let's take
this powers of 2 so we have 16 32
64 128 okay so that's it for the first
and then for this next one we have two
right here
let's have that in your units two there
we go we have the refine let's copy this
again and then we repeat the same for
the drop out so here we have drop out
take this off and then here we have drop
out
for the Dropout we're going to take our
values between 0.1 0.2
0.3 and 0.4 anyway let's let's say we
want to take between 0.1 and 0.3 and
then from the drop out we have the
regularization rate so make sure you see
that we've taken typical values so your
typical values for this number of units
will be this and for the drop out will
be this for the regularization
regularization rates will have different
uh range of typical values so here we
would have 0.00 yeah say 0.001
0.01 and then let's say 0.1 so that's it
uh what's next we have the learning rate
so let's copy this out HP learning rates
and here we have one e negative four one
e negative three okay so that's it for
the learning rate and that should be all
so we have
um nothing left actually so that's fine
so there we go we've defined all those
different ranges so we're gonna search
in this range search in this range
search in this range searching this
range searching this range now notice
that we well this is actually this
actually discrete value so it's not like
we're gonna pick between uh this value
and this value we're just gonna
basically pick this value or this value
or this value or this other value and
now to perform this grid search we're
gonna go
for number of units
um one in this range of specified here
so we're gonna have
um in HP num units one there we go Dot
domain dot values here we have values
there we go and then we're gonna do the
same for this so we have for Num units
two
in HP num units or num units two
that domain that values
and then four
uh the drop out rate
and then the regularization rate in
regularization domain learning rate in
the learning rate domain
um we are now going to
create this HP params dictionary so we
have HP params right here which is going
to be our dictionary and it's going to
contain the different values here so we
will start with this HP uh num units one
and then what you get or what we're
gonna put in here is this value we have
here so the value we pick from this
domain is what we're going to pass in
here so we have num units one
uh one there we go we now repeat the
same process so we just have your two
and then the rest
and there we go we have the remaining
parameters and then from here
we are going to create a file writer so
for each run because here we're gonna
have
um different runs for the different
values so for each run we're gonna
Define the file writer so here we have
the file writer
TF summary create file writer just as
we've seen already so here we have the
file writer and then we specify this
directory now we want the directory to
have uh different names based on the
exact run number so let's say we want to
have round number here which initialize
to zero and then we have this so let's
have this
um logs slash oh let's just put in the
Run number in your
string uh we have the wrong number okay
so that's it we have that and then after
each and every
um
run we want to increment this round
number so yeah we're going to increment
the Run number run
number equal
run or plus equal one plus equal one
okay so that's it now we've defined this
file writer that looks fine
um next thing we want to do is with this
file writer
as default
so we have this default as default
will now log in the current hyper
parameters so we have hp.h params and
then we pass in this current hyper
parameters recall we are going to sweep
through all these different values and
then for a particular round we want to
know exactly what we're passing in
that's what we're going to pass in here
so we have HP Rams that's fine and then
now once we've passed uh once we've
notified tensorboard that this is the
parameters or the hyper parameters we're
working with the next thing we want to
do is to pass this hyper parameters in
this model tune method right here so
here we're going to pass in now this HP
Rams this each problems which we just
defined here which is a function of this
different values we are going to be
sweeping through so yeah we're gonna
have a model tune model tune
which is going to take in the H Rams and
then it's gonna output like from here
it's going to Output this accuracy so
yeah we're gonna have the accuracy so we
have the accuracy which is that and then
once we get this accuracy
we are going to log in as value so we
have TF summary scalar so log in this
killer accuracy
accuracy and then we have the accuracy
value logged in so that looks fine we
have this round number why do we have a
red here
um
that's actually okay now so let's get
back to this now we could run this cell
We Run The Cell everything looks fine
and then we now go straight into this
hyper parameter tuning where we're going
to pick out the best values for our
hyper parameters which actually give us
the best accuracy so
for each step now we want to let's say
print out this so we'll print out
um the HP Rams so our H Rams is so we
have HP Rams there we go and then we
also want to print out
the current run number so what we're
gonna have here is the HP programs or
for
the Run let's specify the Run number
uh HP Rams is that so our H params is
this and then we format so we have that
and then we have the Run number
there we go so let's have this here and
then I'll run this cell so yes what we
get we also modified this code here to
contain each and every value in this ish
params so we get this kind of output and
we we make this run for like
um let's count this for like
287 times so we have 287 different runs
and then from here we run the cell and
then run this two so from here we have
those Killers
um here are the different accuracies to
get anyway we're not very much
interested in this for now because we're
interested in looking at this HP Rams
here now let's start with the stable
view you could see here that we with the
stable view we could see the different
values the different hyper parameters we
made use of are we we tuned throughout
this process so you can see let's scroll
up a little uh here you see we have the
regularization rate number of units drop
out rates and then let's scroll down
again and then go this way you have
um okay so we have number of units two
learning rate and any accuracy so you
see here that the accuracy uh changes
based on the different values we have
for this different hyper parameters here
now another better way of looking at
this is this parallel Cardinals view as
you can see in this parallel coordinates
view you get to like pick out the the
highest accuracy value and then if you
follow this path you get to see that
taking a learning rate of
0.0001 and then year let's just look at
this part so you see you know notice
this red part here
which you can actually turn to Green by
clicking on it so you see it turns to
Green you have 0.0001 and then the
number of units two it's like around 32
yeah we have drop our rate 0.2 number of
units 1 32 uh regularization rates 0.01
so these are the best uh hyper parameter
values we have in
we can now make use of this information
to better create our model so now
instead of having a model like this so
now we will modify this and then instead
of having uh let's get back to what we
had up here
so what we're saying is instead of
having this
year well we had 10 now we could take
this so 32 and then right here it's 32
then we could pick the regularization
rate to 0.01 so I have the 0.01 drop out
rate
um we didn't take we didn't not drop
power rate let's get back to that
um the dropout rate
um 0.1 no no no 0.2 actually so drop
array 0.2
um that looks fine learning rate
0.0001 so that's it so we now see how to
better pick those values thanks to this
hyper parameter tuning which we can do
easily with tensorboard so let's get
back to this and then we have 0.2 right
here
now it should be noted that the method
we've used so far is grid search that is
with
specified those different ranges and
then with some sort of uh search through
these different uh ranges and then we've
gotten the best possible parameters
which
maximize the accuracy value now another
very popular technique is the random
search with a random search
we'll just Define a range and then pick
our random values in that range so
unlike the grid search where we have
some Define or predefined values which
we have to search through with a random
search we kind of like pick values at
random
but then they both have their advantages
and disadvantages and one thing you
could take out from this is that with
the grid search since you have a fixed
range so you have a fixed range of
values which you can pick from it means
if this fixed range of values is very
large it becomes problematic as we this
process of searching is going to take a
very long time
so you may take a very long time before
finding your best um hyper parameter
values
reconnect whereas for the random search
since we're not going in a particular
order it happens that we may even get
the best hyper parameter values after
just one step so after just going
through or after just one run or a few
rounds we may already get the best hyper
parameter values just like we may get
these values
um after 200 different runs so if you
have enough computation power you could
make use of the grid search since you
are more sure of the different values
you're going to be picking from and if
not the random search will be a better
option another very important aspect of
tensorboard is tensorboard's profiler
with tensor boss profiler will be able
to evaluate the tensorflow code and
based on this evaluation modify this
code to ensure that it runs as
efficiently as possible that said to
make use of the profiler we're going to
start by installing this tense about
profiler plugin so we have your people
install this you run the cell the
profile plugin now installed we now go
ahead and run the cells uh right here
we're gonna have this profile batch so
notice that we have this profile batch
right here and this value specified your
has to do it
the range of batches to be profiled
and so here we could take say a hundred
to let's say 132
okay so that's it so we have that set we
are now around the cell tool looks fine
and then we could start with the
training we have The Stance about call
by which has been added here so we run
this just how the training training now
complete we go ahead and run this to
cells
just as expected we have those Killers
we have the graphs we have this
distributions we have this histograms uh
time series and then in here we have
this profile
and you're in this overview page so you
have different pages in this overview
page we have this performance summary
we're given the average Step time all of
the time
compilation time output time input time
notice how this input time is relatively
larger than the others and you'll see
that or you'll notice that you're
the input time occupies the largest part
of the step time so
uh that's why you have as recommendation
to First focus on reducing this input
time
and then we have 75 7.5 percent of total
step time sample is spent and kind of
launch it could be due to CPU contention
with TF data in this case you may try to
set the environment variable TF GPU
Trend mode to GPU private then we have
6.6 percent of the total step time
sample is spent on all of the times this
could be due to python execution
overhead only zero percent of device
competition is 16 bit so you might want
to replace more 32-bit operations by 16
bit operations to improve performance
so this actually means we could make use
of mixed Precision training now we're
going to look at an expedition training
in subsequent section
we also have this other tools we could
use for reducing the input time this
input pipeline analyzer you could click
here you have this input pipeline
analyzer now notice that you have these
different tools here so we have the
other view page the let's go back to
overview page
and then here we have this input
pipeline analyzer
um let's scroll down here we have the
input pattern analyzer we have this TEF
data bottleneck analysis you could click
on this you see we have this TF button
analysis and then you let's get back to
the overview again scroll up and then
you have the stress viewer right here so
you would also find the stress viewer in
your
legal scroll here and you have the trace
View now getting the summary of the
input pipeline analysis uh we get to see
exactly the breakdown of the input
processing time on the host because
we've seen already from here that the
input processing time is kind of
taken up close to 68.4 percent of the
total step time so uh here you could see
we have the data processing which is
like the main reason why this input
processing time is that large and we
have this different steps we could take
so what can be done to reduce above
components of the host input time in
current data
that is you may want to combine small
input data chance into fewer large
chunks data processing you may increase
number of parallel calls in the data set
map or pre-process the data offline
reading data from files in advance
reading data from files on demand or the
data reading or processing and then here
we have a more detailed input operation
statistics so let's click on this scroll
up and then you could have this
Statistics given to you right here so as
you could see we know exactly why
our input processing is taking up much
time and based on this different
suggestions we could reduce this time
now from here we have the kennel stats
then we also have this memory profile
and then we have the part viewer
from this part viewer we have the
tensorflow stats
and then here we have this tensorflow
dealer
bottleneck analysis
you could also look at this from here
you see we have the road prefetch look
at the self duration here 10
microseconds 36 microseconds see this
one now is very large so here's our
bottleneck a level of the mapping and
batching
um shuffling just 118 373 prefetching
and so on and so forth so we now know
that the problem comes from the mapping
as we have seen it uh as we've seen
previously and now selecting this Trace
viewer we have this year and we'll make
use of this here so you could carry this
around by clicking on this and then you
have the arrow you have this to like
pull this from place to place you have
the zoom so you could you have the pen
you have the zoom you have this timing
so let's click on the zoom and then you
see see click you click and you drag to
the top up you could zoom in and zoom
out now you'll notice the strain we have
values from a hundred like let's get
back to what we had defined previously
here we have a Honda 232 and that's why
you'll notice here we have this train
from 100 to 132 to getting back here you
can zoom see you have that and then you
could click here on the pan and then you
pull this to one side now stopping right
here you could zoom again and then you
get to see all those different
operations carried out during a single
process
all those different operations carried
out during a single training step
and with this timing tool you click on
this time and Tool you can be able to
like let's Zoom this again
and zoom and then drag this here Zoom
again
as we're saying measure the timing for a
given operation so once you click here
you just click and then you see you drag
and you can measure timing for different
operations you see you have the time
you're uh 166.5 microseconds
and that's it we now go on the
distributions here we have batch
normalization Branch normalization let's
check out on this comp 2D you see that
uh different uh biases and weights
that's you see the kernel is the weights
have values which fall under this uh
Zone slash the values fall under or the
values are between 0.30 negative 0.3 0.3
for the biases between uh negative 1.2
uh about 0.4 and then for conf this
dense we have the sort of dense layer
here we have this conf2d2
you could see here instead of the range
of values and then we have the dense one
we have the dense two we also have the
different uh value ranges for both the
canals and the biases so that's it for
this distributions we have the
histograms two you could check this out
um time series anyway this time series
is kind of similar
to information we've seen already so
here we have this all we could select
just as killers so here we have the
hippo class we have the different uh
evaluation accuracy and so on and so
forth now click on images you select
only images
um nothing to be shown see that's why
you have no information here click on
histogram and then you have the
histogram data we've just seen already
that's it for the section intense about
tensorboard as other functionalities
which we shall explore subsequently and
thank you for getting right up to this
point
hello everyone and welcome to another
amazing session in which we're gonna see
how to work with weights in biases and
integrate it with our already existing
tensorflow code base wasting biases help
practitioners in experiment tracking
collaborative reports data set and model
versioning interactive data
visualization and Hyper parameter
optimization is trusted by over a
hundred thousand plus machine learning
practitioners around the world in this
session we are going to focus on
experiment tracking it's one thing to
build a model train this model and
evaluate it on a given data set and at
least as we've seen throughout those
cars this is pretty easy with tensorflow
but when we're working in large teams
and we have to collaborate we have to
produce reproducible results we need to
debug those ml models as a team and we
also need to enforce transparency then a
machine learning operations platform
like weights and biases becomes
indispensable with symbiases permissions
build better models faster with
experiment tracking that are visioning
and Model Management as of now the
different products which weights and
biases offers to us are experiment
tracking reporting that's producing
collaborative dashboards artifacts data
set and model versioning just like how
you would do code versioning in git uh
interactive data visualization and Hyper
parameter optimization now also you
could see here that this has been used
by modern a hundred thousand machine
learning practitioners around the world
some key aspects of this weights and
buyers tool are the fact that you could
integrate very quickly you see that with
kiras so here we're supposing we are
building a Keras Model A tensorflow
Keras model and then all you need to do
is to import this 1db callback right
here start a new run as is given year
um if you have some configurations you
you set those configurations and then in
the place of the callbacks you simply
pass this weights and bias callback
which we imported right here so it's
quite easy to integrate with already
existing all Frameworks now you see with
any framework you just need to do
1db.log and you could lock any
information you want a lot we could also
visualize useful information very
seamlessly and then we could collaborate
in real time so here um if you're
working on a project you could all as
part of the team discuss the Project's
progression and see how to eliminate any
bugs or any problems now weights and
biasis is designed for all use cases so
here we have a practitioner that's we're
supposed in just a single person you
have this dashboard Central dashboard
you can look at you see this hyper
parameter sweeps artifacts your you
could do data set and model versioning
just like you would do with GitHub code
reports to share updates very
transparently
throughout those cars we'll look at this
different products and in this section
we'll focus on experiment tracking we're
not going to go straight forward into
signing up so we click right here
want to sign up with GitHub click here
and then we authorize 1db to get access
to our neural learning account so
authorize 1db
we have the full name organization
neural learn and that's fine okay so I
agree to the terms and conditions you
could always uh read out those terms and
conditions very carefully and then from
here we also have to put in this
username so let's say neural learn and
okay so we continue uh how often do you
train models let's say every week so we
have that and then get started here's
now home page here you could create a
new project you could uh modify a
profile invite your team you have this
documentation you click right here docs
dot 1db.ai with the different guides
references which you could always make
use of in case you are having any
difficulties or as a starter you want to
master how all this work then you also
have this fully connected right here
which brings ml practitioners together
now here you'll have curated tutorials
conversations with industry leaders deep
dives into newest ml research and a
whole lot more so you would always have
this information
others curated information at your
disposal then we also have the community
and then we have this quick stat for the
different framework so we could view all
Frameworks here
and getting back you see we have pytorch
Keras we're working with Keras click on
Keras you would have this quick start
for Keras users which we actually so
here you see you see how easy it is to
get started with 1db in Keras the very
first step we'll take would be to
install and log into 1db so we'll simply
copy this and then get back to our
collab notebook we pay this out right
here and then run the cell we have the
syntax error let's have this and then we
run there we go as you can see 1db has
been installed from here we're gonna get
into the login now you see you can find
your API key in your browser here so we
could click on this link get the API key
and then paste it out here now let's get
back to this and then copy out this API
key there there we go we have that and
then we paste it out here so we paste it
out there or you could click on this
link can and still get the key which we
can paste in here and then simply press
on enter so we hit enter and we should
be able to log in since we have this key
put in right here now Moving On To The
Next Step at the top of your training
script start a new run and to start this
new one we are going to make use of this
init method getting back to the
documentation you have your uh run is a
unit of computation locked by 1db
typically this is an ex an ml experiment
so we create a run with the 1db init so
before moving on you should note that
you could create a project and in this
project you have several runs now one
run could be for training so we could
have a training run like some sort of ml
experiment as defined here and then we
have evaluation
and you could have other different runs
or other different
um train meaning processes which will
act as different runs here as you can
see when you just import 1db the run is
known and now you have 1 DB init once
you have once you make a call with this
you on this method you have a run which
is automatically created and so
everything you're gonna log in into 1db
will be sent to that particular run so
if you have say this project let's call
this project malaria prediction project
if you have a malaria prediction project
and then we have this training run
everything like once we create this run
everything we log in will be sent into
this particular run right here and then
if we create another run that's
evaluation run everything we log in will
be stored in this particular run here so
getting back here you see you could
create this run and you could finish or
you could stop that run
and that's why yeah once you have this
you need you've created a run you stop
the run and then you're normally this uh
should be known as there should be no
run going uh no one created now after
doing this you could also create this
like here like 1db that you need you
could put this
um
in a width block so we have with 1 DB
init as run then you now have all the
data to be locked in your
such that out of this width block you
have no run
from here you could check out on the
different attributes and then the
information related to these attributes
now let's get into this 1db Elite One DB
neat you have as definition with all the
different arguments it takes and then
you have this
um
information concerning all those
different arguments so yeah we could
Define like we have this run which we
could create by simply doing one to be
neat and then we'll specify the project
specify the entity I will say neural
learn
um the project malaria detection the
configuration all the information we'll
be needing let's say for training it
will specify safe code
to permit One DB save our code but I
default this is actually false so by
default your code is not going to be
saved to 1 DB you could check this out
here let's have safe code let's search
that save code
um go up and there we go so by default
we don't allow this
and you could flip this Behavior by
going to settings page now you could
check on all these other arguments you
have this job type argument tool which
is also very very important and this is
very useful when you're grouping runs
together into larger experiments using
this group argument right here
now that said let's copy this part of
this code and then get back to our
notebook uh we'll notice that we have
this Imports so we would have to
um finish uh put out those Imports here
let's have this we have import 1db from
1db Keras in Part One DB callback let's
take this off so we produce two here and
then we we run the cell
that should be fine now that's run we
scroll down we have the model let's run
this again and then
let's actually get back here and create
this run so let's have this here so 1db
init we're going to specify the project
we're gonna create this so this is 1 DB
install login
and install login and initialization so
we have that now as we've said already
this is going to parameters create a run
so here let's have malaria detection
malaria detection and one way the like
to write this out like prefer to put
this hyphen instead of the space so
let's have that that way so we have here
malaria detection
um entity neural learn and let's have
that for now so let's run the cell and
then let's add this code below here
currently login as neural learn and
that's fine from here let's now do 1db
dot run see what we get from here we see
that we have no metrics locked yet so
that's fine we could now take this off
and then go straight away to add our 1db
callback to tensorflow uh before that we
have save model all inputs and Hyper
parameters so 1db config let's have this
copied and then we have that before
defining the model let's copy that and
then just here we'll add this code cell
again and then let's have your
initialization configuration and there
we go okay so we have that when to be
config learning rate specified number of
epochs batch size would include the drop
out rate the image size regularization
rate number of filters Canal size number
of strides pool size number of outputs
for the first dense layer number of
outputs for the second dance layer it
was as fine we now run the cell so we've
now stored this configurations then the
next and last step is to Simply have
this callback in this fit method so
let's copy this out and then get back so
we have that we've run our model let's
be sure we've run this model
and
just here let's have this configuration
let's say we have our configuration
configuration equal our 1db DOT config
and then right here we have
configuration and M size and we have
same for the other hyper parameters like
the dropout rate regularization rate
number of filters Canal size pull size
and number of strides we now go ahead to
the training process so we copy this out
and paste just right here so here we'll
have this callbacks let's take this off
instead of this tensorflow tensorboard
callback we had we now have this 1db
callback so we have this one DB callback
and you could always even include the
tensorboard Callback so you could also
have the tensorboard call that we had
previously now there we go we have this
1db callback let's have that and then we
run the cell for metrics we compile the
model once the models compiled uh let's
um include this learning rate so let's
have this
configuration and then we'll specify the
learning rates so we have that learning
rate there and then we compile the model
and start with the training now the
training is complete we could go to our
weights and bias dashboard right here
and see exactly what went under in the
training process so here we have this
projects you could see here and neural
learn we have the projects we click on
this malaria prediction project and then
we select this run the runway selecting
here is this Sandy water run so there we
go now you see we have 19 different
chats here you see
validation loss false positive false
positive
um well this is Epoch versus ebook so
that's why you have this uh kind of
straight line and then you have this
position recall loss through negative to
positive accuracy in fact all this is
basically gotten from all this metrics
we've had here so this means that
with this simple callback we have put
Right Here Waiting by us is able to get
all this or capture all this information
during the training process and give it
to us or present it to us after we're
done with the training so here we can
see uh those different
um charts with we already used to seeing
this already so you should be already
familiar with this different chats
now apart from this charts you have the
system information so here we have the
CPU utilization we have the system
memory utilization process memory news
process memory news
while this is in megabytes here we have
this information in the percentage uh
with respect to the total memory
available then here we have process
memory available process CPU threads in
use disk utilization Network traffic uh
GPU utilization GPU temperature so you
could have this information here GPU
time spent GPU memory allocated GPU
power usage
and so you see how easy it is to get all
this system information without writing
any extra line of code now from here we
could go on to the model you see we have
this um table right here which shows our
model it's kind of similar to the model
summary we had pulled out previously so
um yeah it's kind of similar to what we
had here so now we have instead of that
we have this beautiful table right here
output shape number of parameters type
and the name so that's it and then from
here we have this logs so we have
everything that was locked out like
all we had here so you see everything
locked out
we have it in this run now recall that
when the when doing this 1db neat last
year once we do this one will be neat we
actually create a run and once that run
is created everything we do after that
is going to be starting that run and
that's why if you notice you're like and
you don't only have this information
that not only this training information
but even this data which was locked even
this model because we ran this several
times so you see here
that even this information which was
locked is actually stored by 1db and so
you see that experiment tracking here is
done very easily and actually seamlessly
now you look at the files we start you
have the model best see you have
automatically this
um Keras
model file which is start you have this
meta dealer you could open this up and
you have this information start you see
that we're using a Tesla P 100 GPU so
that's it uh python version operating
system version and then other
information like the GPU count or CPU
count and so on and so forth so that's
it
um let's get back to this overview see
it's still running that's because we
have our collab notebook still running
right here now one thing you could
always count on is this documentation
right here so you just come straight to
those integration and then you pick out
Keras you would have your Keras and then
you have this 1db Keras 1db callback
then right here you have this now you
could see this arguments all those
different arguments we have here and you
have the explicit definitions here so
let's check out on this arguments you
you see we have a monitor the validation
loss
which plays a similar role to this model
checkpoint callback right here
and also we could specify the mode so
let's get back to the documentation uh
what we uh okay so we get back to this
mode so you could pick out the mode by
default is automatic
um
we could also select mean on Max in the
case of validation loss obviously would
select a mean and the case of if we're
dealing with a validation accuracy or
validation Precision or recall then
we'll select the mode to Max such that
we're saving our model when we have the
maximum Precision or maximum recall for
example here we have the save model save
graph save weights only lock weights
gradients training dealer violation data
now you should know that with this we're
able to pass in our data set to 1db and
the fact that we pass in this data to
1db can permit us come up with some
visualizations of what the model is
predicting since now we have the theater
now we also have the generator
validation steps levels predictions
input type and so on and so forth so you
could always check out on this now the
next thing we'll be doing is take the
value Innovation theater passed into
this 1db callback right here and then be
able to visualize the different
predictions as we go through the
training process so let's break this up
a little we have this training
validation number of epochs this should
actually be configuration
configuration number
of ebooks number of ebooks okay so we
have that and then we have the verbosity
callbacks now in this 1db callback right
here we have validation
validation
data which is of all data set and then
from here let's check out the
documentation and then we have the
levels and the data type so let's
specify the levels from here we have
levels
and the levels we have here we have
parasitized
and
uninfected
anyway we could create this like we
could have the classes so we could have
your levels
and then specify this so let's just take
this off from here
uh connect and then paste it out here
okay so we have that and then let's have
this levels
now we have the level we could also
specify the data type so that's how we
specify this to be image okay we have
that number of epochs and all of that
let's go ahead and modify this number of
ebooks here so number of ebooks 100
let's change this let's just have three
ebooks for now so let's get back uh I
want to be config we should have this up
here so once we make this we get this
new configuration so we run that looks
fine we get back to the training from
here now we could run this training
again training complete let's go ahead
and check out on what has been locked in
our dashboard so let's have this year we
pick out this run there we go we see we
have still around 19 different chats and
then we have this media which has been
added here we click on this and you see
what we get
as you could see here we have the
different images and the predictions you
could view full screen mode by doing
this
and then just your you could select the
step so if you pull this to the end you
see we have 36 steps meaning we have
trained for over 36 different epochs
now selecting this malaria detection
project and
having all those three different runs
right here you see you could view all
the runs
simultaneously so I could click on this
one you have this is one run actually
this is another run so I could view all
this now simultaneously right here
see we have that you see the difference
in uh GPU power usage with this two
different runs that's the Sandy water to
run and this exalted Knight to rerun
and then from here if you want to stop
around us if you want to stop this
current exalted Knight to rerun what we
could do is come right here that is
um let's say we let's have this code
here we could come right here and just
simply put out 1db dot finish so we call
this and we should be able to stop this
uh the current run
you can always check out on this 1db the
Run documentation right here to get more
information about this you see here uh
this example given where the create the
run and then stop the run and then this
shows that there is no current run and
then after creating the recreating the
run you see that there is now a run so
um this is simply how we could stop this
run and that's what we've just done here
we could simply run the cell
and after running the cell you have this
run summary you see the accuracy and the
other different metrics and loss values
notice how the different metrics and
losses have been put out in this command
line formatting so you could see how
those loss for example your drops and
then getting back to our dashboard we
see that there is no current run then
we've again recreated a new run with the
one to be neat right here so we've
created this new one on this elevator we
could check it out here you see we
created this neuron you can see this uh
Little Green Cycle right here coming
back to the notebook we have this 1db
callback which we've used so far in
login information into weights and
biases but then this is limited because
we are yet able to Define our own custom
callbacks now that said let's get back
to this callbacks we have defined here
here we have this log images callback
we're gonna actually try to log images
into wasting biases using this callback
which we have created now recall that to
create this kind of custom callbacks you
inherit from the Callback class in
tensorflow and then you get to put in
some code in your
which defines that custom callback now
we've just copied this and pasted it
right here the difference here is this
is 1 DB so this is what we had for
tensorboard and this one of 1db you're
gonna see how easy it is even though
we're building this custom callbacks so
right here
so let's suppose we want to predict or
rather we want to lock this confusion
matrices and want to lock this to
weights and biases now what we'll do is
we're going to take off all this here so
let's get back this is what we did with
tensorboard we saw that we had to make
use of my employee and then log this
information into tensorboard but here
what we have or what we need to do to
lock the coefficient Matrix is simply
just this part this code right here so
here what we have is uh we'll take all
this off see we take all this code right
here off
uh take this off oh let's have that so
we have this code yeah right here taken
off and then we just left with this so
you see that instead of having to write
all this code all we need now to write
is just this one now if you're wondering
why uh how to get the other plots or
what other plots we could get
automatically like this with Waiting by
us we get into those weights and bias
GitHub repository and here we have
um we have this link or 1db client three
Master 1db plot you see all the
different plots we have now and census
constantly under development surely in
some time to come we will have many more
of this different plots we could do very
easily so here we have a bar the py
confusion Matrix you see we have the
confision metrics histogram line line
series position recall curve Roc curve
and Scatter prpy so this means that
already we could plot out those
confusion Matrix and the ROC curve very
easily
with with bias so let's get back to this
we'll check this out first thing we have
noticed this law 1db the log so whenever
you're using this 1db callback here
what's actually happen uh what happens
under the hood is this information has
been locked like this
so we have we make use of this one to be
log and then here we are gonna have
let's change this let's say confusion
confusion Matrix anyway let's write like
this okay here we have the conversion
Matrix and then you have 1db plot
confusion Matrix you could modify this
and put PR curved aspiration recall
curve or Roc curve and that's it and
then this props then we have y true
um pretz the predictions and then the
class names so here we should change
this class names and have
our size for us it's sized and what do
we have here we have uninfected
and then you can either pass the
probabilities or this predicted score so
here we're gonna have props equal
I did that since water model predicts or
whatever outputs are these probabilities
and then the Y true is equal levels from
here we're going to take out the spreads
because we've done that already so let's
have this here there we go this doesn't
take into consideration the threshold so
we take off this threshold that said now
we have this
um callback 1db and then we're ready to
train our model
after the training process we have those
results which look great and we could
now go ahead to look at the confusion
Matrix bloated in the dashboard so let's
get to our dashboard and this is what we
should have let's get back to runs and
then click on this
current run and this is what we get now
we see that we have those coefficient
Matrix which doesn't
actually show us
what we expect to get and this is simply
because the way this was conceived are
the way this
uh call back here this login was
conceived was such that we have
a multi-class problem so even in the
case where we have a binary
classification uh problem like in this
case we expect to have an output of two
values so that's why when you have this
output let's get down here
click on this as at this code so that's
why when you have the value like say and
the output 0.9
it's considered to be parasitized
although we defined already that
parasitized
is meant to be zero uninfected equal one
and so when we have 0.9 this is greater
than the midpoint of this 2 which is 0.5
so we should consider this as uninfected
but the way as we've said already the
way this has been conceived is such that
even in the binary classification
problem we shouldn't or we don't have a
single output but two outputs that is if
we have a value of 0.9
what 1db expects to see something like
this something like zero and 0.9 so
showing that your oh let's let's even
put your zero one even zero points let's
say 0.8 and 0.2
okay so let's have this so even in this
case it goes back to the same output so
this simply means that we are having
an unaffected cell since this first
index here has a higher value
now to solve this issue what we're gonna
do is we're gonna take each and every
output we have and convert it to this
format so in the case where we have for
example 0.1 as output we're gonna
convert it into one zero because this
means that the higher uh the Sim this
one means that it's prosthetized cell
and this two means the same because here
we're seeing that this zeroth index
which is the proselytized uh index
has a higher value hence this is a
processed cell
so that said what we're going to do now
is for all values less than 0.5 we could
say less than yeah 0.5 we are going to
convert it into
zero sorry we're gonna convert into one
zero and then for all values greater
than 0.5 we're going to convert them
into 0 1. so this the transformation
we're going to make in other for this
one DB log method to correctly log our
values
but note that if we're having a
multi-classification problem it will be
needless doing this transformation so
let's get straight away and see how
we're going to transform this into this
required format right here let's start
by copying out this first part let's
copy this into this other cell here and
once we run this we have this output
right here then we could go ahead and
modify this predicted so what we now
have is we will Define the spread this
other list and then for Iron Range
um Range the length of predicted we're
gonna make sure that if
the value
that I
we're going to take this zeroed index if
it's less than 0.5
then what we have to do is append this
to this list spread right here so what
we're going to append is one zero
because this is less than 0.5 so
um if it was a multi-class problem we
would have the highest or the higher
value in this case since we just have in
two classes we have the higher value
representing this output which was
predicted which happens to be less than
0.5 so we have here one and then yeah
we'll have else
red append
what do we have next we have zero one so
here we have zero one let's take this
off zero one and that's fine so yeah
we've modified the spread and then we
could then print out the print
so with this now we should be able to
have the expected output there we go we
have this output let's add this code
cell
and then print out a bright shape we run
this and what do we get you see we have
exactly what we expect so that's it
let's copy out this part from here and
then we're gonna add this here
so we have this right now let's have
this forward and then we're gonna have
red equal NP dot array of print so we'll
convert it into a numpy array before
passing into this log method console
that should be fine okay so that's it
now we have this set everything looks
fine let's take this off and have that
print so we have the spread now
everything looks okay and we could now
rerun or restart our training so let's
have this here let's take this off from
here we train again for just about two
epochs and then your other results we
get so we can click on this run here and
then you could have the tables and the
custom chats let's start with the custom
chats you can expand this this way so
here you see that we have the predicted
and the actual so we have the model you
see now that we have this number of true
let's say true positives which increases
number of true negatives which also
increase while we have this number of
false negatives to be 112 or here we
have 62. this is uh
1305 and when you compare this with this
previous run you see that now we're
having reasonable outputs as with this
previous run we had that error
where the confusion Matrix method of 1db
considers all the outputs to be
parasitized let's have this Mac and take
this off
then from here we could go ahead and to
look at how to plug the ROC plots let's
get back here scroll up uh what we do is
here we just have to let's come in this
here and then now do the same for the
ROC plots
let's get back to the GitHub repo and
click on this Roc curve here in this
here we have now those arguments which
have been described so here we have y
true y probabilities obviously this is
the level predicted and then the classes
the class names classes to plot that is
a set of classes which we are going to
plot or we're gonna exclude all classes
which aren't specified in this classes
to plot argument now this is actually
optional so you don't necessarily need
to have this we also have this title so
let's copy this out let's copy out this
um here let's copy this out and paste
just right here we then specify the
levels why true levels
here we have red and then right here we
have this class names so let's copy this
out and paste your
okay so that's what we have let's run
the cell everything looks fine and then
we start with the training training now
complete here are the results we
obtained we get back to our dashboard
and that's what we have you could go
back to the runs and you'll see that you
click on this custom charts right here
no let's click on this run here first
and then we have this two custom charts
so we have those previous conversion
metrics which we logged in and then now
we have this Roc curve which we just
plotted out we could also check out the
tables for the ROC curve and the
confision Matrix so here we go we have
this Roc plot and then we have this
those two plots here where one is for
the uninfected and the other is for the
parasitized class I haven't seen how to
plot the confusion metrics and the ROC
curve we could check out the
documentation and look at the other
plots so here we have a basic chart
lines cutter bar chart histogram multi
line
and the next model evolution charts like
what we've just done the completion
metrics Roc curves PR curves that's
Precision recall curves you have the
mirror interactive custom charts uh
matte per leap and partly plot so this
means you could actually come up with
your own plot with mapler leave and then
log that to 1db and then apart from this
method in which we use the 1db Callback
here
oh no not this one the one DB callback
we had defined previously that's apart
from using that 1db callback to lock the
loss metrics and other information we
could directly just do 1db the log and
then we say for example we want to lock
the loss so we just put out loss and
then since we got the loss from this
locks we have this locks here
we scroll down and then we put out your
locks locks and then we specify the loss
so this all what it suffices to lock
this lost values from here you could
also lock the accuracy and all the
metrics
it's actually a dictionary so let's have
that and there we go so we've seen how
to lock these values now let's also see
how the log images like with this we
have this image
and then we log this to tensorboard now
we'll see how to get this image and then
log it to 1db to lock those images wood
and check out here on the documentation
and you'll see that you could lock rich
media files that's really any kind of
media file 3D Point clouds molecules
HTML and histograms so that said you'll
scroll down and you have this code here
which primates us lock image theater so
here's login erasers images login
pil images logging images from files
image overlays segmentation masks
bounding boxes and so on and so forth so
you have this you also have this
histograms you have 3D visualizations as
you can see one in cloud and molecules
so you see that 1db actually permits
just any practitioner be able to lock
any data or any kind of data they really
want to lock hence making them more
efficient so that's it let's get back to
this here we log in arrays let's copy
this out let's click here click just
simply copy that way and then you get
back to the code so yeah what we're
saying is we want to lock we want to be
able to lock those images at this level
so let's paste this out somewhere here
and then copy out this part again we're
going to copy this part recall that
um with this 1db we have defined here we
we kind of like got we ended at this
level where we got the levels and the
predicted and automatically
we got this Roc curve and coefficient
metrics now what we want to do is get
right up to this point where we actually
have the image that is r on image which
we've created and then from this image
log e to 1 DB and so right here we have
this piece of code here and we're going
to integrate this uh one thing we could
do again let's copy this again now let's
copy this other one because here we have
the image so we'll copy this again we
consider that this is for tensorboard
um let's write your tensor bar tensor
board okay we have that for 10 support
we have this for 1db now uh One DB plot
and then this next one is just 1 DB um
let's add this here there we go okay so
here we have this
1db that's fine so what we're saying is
we're gonna take off all this here so we
take all this all off
and then we copy this out
let's cut that out and then paste it
here
so there's how we're gonna lock this to
1db and as usual it's going to always be
simpler than what we have with the
tensor board so just all we need to do
here is just to take our image and then
lock as simple as that now our image
array here let's have let's see this
image area image erases output which we
have and then we pass this image array
into this caption let's put the caption
let's say confusion confusion Matrix for
ebook and then we get the ebook from
here like we have this Epoch so we're
going to be logging this confusion
Matrix for each and every ebook so we
just put out this ebook here and that's
fine so yeah that's a caption we have a
1db image and we lock it in here let's
have this let's say confusion
confusion Matrix
or yeah confusion Matrix okay let's have
that uh now we run this we copy anyway
we had that already let's copy this out
we have in an error
um here this should be closed okay so
that's fine we have this 1db log right
here and everything looks okay okay so
let's run that again and check this out
looks fine now we could go ahead and
start with the training let's run this
this should be okay now and compile the
model after compile the model we now go
ahead and train the model let's say we
want to have three here let's keep that
aside for now and then here we have this
let's paste it out it should be the same
okay yeah we have it now let's run the
training process and see what we get
training now complete we can get back to
our dashboard and see what we have as
plots we'll click on this here
this run the current run we have uh this
is a media we locked previously now
let's check in this hidden panels and
see what we get and it happens that we
have this confusion Matrix locked in
this hidden panels anyways we have that
and what do you notice you see for the
three different ebooks you see for the
three you could go to the second and
then go to the third ebook start with
the first you see we have the confusion
matrices which should be locked per
Epoch and now let's do this so it
appears clearer and we see we have this
number of true positives
um true negatives false positives false
negatives and so on and so forth so
that's it from here you can notice how
this value gives some leave some 68 to
52 and then finally we have 53. now
another interesting functionality is you
could simply have that see you could
download it and now you have this full
screen and you can see that Clary so
let's Let's Escape close and then get
back so that's it that's how we lock
this image very easily with 1db now
getting back to the documentation you
might have noticed that you have your
Keras and then you have tens of flow
somewhere around okay you have
tensorflow you see that these are kind
of like considered to be two separate
libraries
but then just note that if you're
building Keras model that's if you're
building this kind of model where you
have uh
you're making use of this method this
feed method to train your model then
making use of this careras documentation
right yours appropriate but then
sometimes you
want to have control or full control
over what you're doing and then you want
to be able to do custom Training like we
had seen previously let's scroll down
okay custom Training Loop so if you're
having a custom Training Loop like with
this year you'd find that you would not
be able to use the 1db Callback as
easily as you had done with the Keras
code so in that case you'll see that
instead of having like for example like
here we have training block and then we
have this loss here all you need to do
is come and put in the 1db you log and
then you lock the loss so yeah you just
say loss and then you simply lock this
last let's say last numpy and that's all
so that's what it takes now to lock this
last values
um the different metrics and so on and
so forth the integration with
tensorboard has been made quite easy too
so if you're already using tensorboard
it's easy to integrate with 1db now here
they say how 1db is different from 10
subord
um the ability to reproduce models
automatic organization fast flexible
integration persistent centralized
dashboard powerful tables and tools for
collaboration
that said let's copy this out let's copy
this again and now when we'll be
creating a run with our init method
we're gonna instead have this so let's
get back to our code
um let's reduce this year and then stop
this run so we have this 1db finish we
stop the run the Run stopped and then
we're gonna create this other neuron
which will take into consideration uh
tensor bar logs so let's get back to the
top and just write your pieces out we've
already had this so if we take this off
now let's comment this and then let's
have project entity just copy that and
paste out here that's fine uh
configuration we have that sync tensor
bar that's fine okay let's run this now
we get this error so let's take this off
here now this isn't compatible with
version 2 of tensorflow which is what
we're using so let's run this again and
this now should be fine we now have
created this new run let's scroll down
and we get to our custom Training Loop
so we're gonna run this we have the
optimizer metric metric validation
ipokes number specified and then let's
say we have this as configuration
and then we have an ebooks
and ebooks okay so that's it uh we have
all this set and then we run this we've
seen this already under the section
tensorboard we get this warning when
using several event log directories like
what we're doing right here please call
tens of 1db10 support patch and then
specify the root log directory before
the one to be neat so let's take this
from here
copy this out and even if you check in
the documentation you should have that
so here you have this here the 1db 1db10
support patch and then
you have this root directory right here
so this means again we're gonna stop the
current run where are we exactly let's
stop this current run it should be at
the level of training we're going to
stop this current Tron here we run this
again we stop that run and then what we
do now is we have this here
and then we'll specify locks so we have
that root directory specified now we
have the root directory specified that's
logs uh get my documentation we have
that specified before the init so we
have to run that before the init
um looks fine let's run this now
um let's run the cell and there we go
uh yeah we took tensorboard already
patched remove the sentence about true
from one to be in it so since we've
already done this patch we should remove
this from one we need okay let's take
that off and run again we're still
getting the error so what we'll do is
we'll just get back and then have that
and then we'll just go as we started
initially so let's run this this should
work now
from here we're gonna continue with what
we're about to do with a custom Training
process
so let's scroll down okay so we are got
into this point we have to and anyway
we'll run this already so that's fine
now let's recommend this one and then
run the cells run this neural and Method
and then start the training process as
you can see training now complete let's
go ahead and launch tensorboard we have
the last values and accuracy values
which have been logged in you could see
them here let's reduce this validation
accuracy and the validation loss now
from this we're now going to look at our
1db logs so we click on this run and we
see we have this log data in here you
see we have the train we have the plot
for the loss we have the plug for the
accuracy and we have the platform the
global step then for the validation you
see we have this year we have the robots
tab validation loss and validation
accuracy exactly what we have with
tensorboard without adding any extra
um line of code for the 1db that is the
only thing we actually did was at this
point here like at this point here we
said we wanted to sync tensorboard so
this is all we need to sync tensorboard
with 1db so if you have been using 10
support or if you are using tensorboard
on a particular project that's all you
need to lock your information now to 1db
apart from this you'll notice this
tensor board here so you can click on
that we're spinning up you can support
instance hang tight take a about 30
seconds and we'll keep it online as long
before I've been completing the sentence
you have this already so you see we have
the stencil board which has been locked
here we have the Spy torch profiler
and then time series skillers just
exactly what we have with tensorboard so
that sounds cool we have the logs we
have the different files which have been
saved system information
and we have this charts and then
overview where we could see all this
information and then get back to our
runs so that's it we've seen how to sync
tensorboard with 1db
and so now you're ready to track your
experiments with 1db thank you for
getting around to this point and see you
next time
hello everyone and welcome to this
session in which we are going to treat
hyper parameter tuning with weights and
biases there are three methods available
for us to implement hyper parameter
tuning in weights and biases that is the
random search the grid search and the
bias in search method at the end of the
session you'll be able to search for the
most suitable parameter values which
optimize the accuracy previously we saw
how to implement hyper parameter tuning
with tensorboard we created this model
tune method which takes us arguments H
params that's hyper parameters which are
actually going to be tuned as you could
see here and then we have in as output
of this models in method the accuracy so
what we're trying to do here is we're
trying to tune or we're trying to obtain
the optimal values for this different
hyper parameters which maximize the
accuracy of the model the exact method
we used was agreed search with a grid
search method we actually go through
each and every option or each and every
possibility and for each possibility we
are gonna log its accuracy as we did
right here now with weights and biases
we're gonna see how to redo this but in
an easier and more reliable manner so
let's check out the documentation right
here see we have this documentation here
we have hyper parameter tuning we could
click on the sweeps quick start with
shows globally what uh permanent tuning
with Western biases and Tails we set up
with some biases we configure The Sweep
we initialize a sweep we launch agents
we visualize the results and then
finally stop the agent from here we'll
see how to run this sweeps in Jupiter so
the weights and biases sweeps allow you
to ease easily try out a large number of
hyper parameters while tracking model
performance and logging all the
information you need to reproduce
experiments now you're going to focus on
this uh Pew python method where
The Sweep configurations are in the form
of a dictionary like this
the way those sweeps work or the way
wasting by accessory work is we have a
central sweep server that is this one
year the central sweep server
and then we have this different agents
right here we could have many more
agents then once we set the
configurations The Sweep configurations
in this Central sweep server right here
the agents now take over and do the
actual hyper parameter tuning that is a
search for the best hyper parameters
which help in optimizing the model and
the spiral method of implementing sweeps
in ways and biases help make the hyper
parameter tuning process even more
efficient as you could see here this
could be done in just two steps
initialize the sweep and
put all necessary information up give
all necessary information for this
Central or to this Central sweep server
and then we run this different agents
right here now that said we have this
fifth configuration which looks similar
to what we had we when we're working
with tensorboard so here we had this
configuration right here where we
specify for each hyper parameter the
values you can take given that we're
having a great search or making use of
grid search algorithm or specifying
simply all those different values and
that was it and now coming back to
widths and biases you see here you just
need to specify for example the hyper
parameter that number of ebooks give the
values learning rate for example you
give the minimum and maximum value
and so on and so forth but then note
that here this as in this example given
the documentation the method you're
using is not a grid search that is then
going through each and every possibility
in the list of values what they're doing
here is actually a random search which
happens to be more efficient than the
grid search algorithm
since it's possible in a shorter period
of time to get very
optimal values of the hyper parameters
as compared to the grid search algorithm
where you need to go through each and
every value
now let's get back here we have the name
we have the method and we have the
parameters to understand where all this
come from check out in this sweep
configuration right here so click on the
script configuration we have the
structure of a sweep configuration then
here we have the different keys and the
descriptions you'll notice this method
which we had seen here let's open this
in the tab open a new tab and have that
so let's have it this way there we go we
have this name method and parameters
which we could see here we have name
method parameters
and then for each of those configuration
Keys like this method for example there
is this more explicit description so
here we have the method you're going to
use if it's agreed grid search iterates
over all possible combinations of
parameter values the random search
chooses a random set of values on each
iteration and weights and biases also
comes with this other method which is
the bias method this bias in hyper
parameter search method uses a gaussian
process to model a relationship between
the parameters and the model metric and
chooses parameters to optimize the
probability of improvement the strategy
requires the metric key to be specified
so right here we see now we have these
three different methods and that is why
your when we wanted to work with the
random it suffice us to just put this
out here either you put it random or you
put Grid or you put bias Now we move to
the next we have the parameters uh yeah
we have the parameters anyway the name
just you could put uh the name for the
sweep that depends on you like here's my
sweep then the parameters here it gets a
little bit more tricky because here you
have this year this key and then the
value is a dictionary which itself is
having its own keys and values so we
have this parameters let's get back to
parameters here we have the parameters
where are we we have parameters and then
we have this different possible values
and the descriptions so getting back
here you'll notice that this hyper
parameter epochs takes values in this
list that is added 10 20 or 50 while the
learning rate can be chosen between
0.001
0.0001 and the maximum 0.1 so each hyper
parameter has its own distinct way of
describing the values you can take now
get him back here we have okay we have
the uh different we have these
parameters and then for those values you
see you can take you can say values you
can say a value so sometimes like here
we may decide and say okay when does
ebook to take only just one value then
we just have value and then in the case
we want several values you see it
specifies all valid values for this
hyper parameter compatible with grid and
all of that now here in some cases you
have a distribution
and this selects a distribution from the
distribution table below so you could
see here this specifies how values will
be distributed if they selected randomly
easy with a random or biased method so
when whether when working with the
random or biased methods you may want to
select your values based on a given
distribution and your other list of
distributions you can use you have
constant categorical or int uniform
uniform distribution cure uniform log
uniform cure lock uniform normal
distribution cure normal log normal and
q log normal
then from this distribution we now move
to mean Max min max is what you actually
saw here yeah you had this min max so
you're simply saying you want your
learning rate to fall or to have a
minimum value of this and the maximum
value of that so it randomly pick values
between this in this range and that's it
you have m u m u mean parameter for
normal or log normal distributed hyper
parameters so here you're having a
normally distributed hyper parameters
and you're specifying the mean while
here you're specifying the standard
deviation then for Q you have the
quantization step size for concise hyper
parameter our next key is a metric and
with a metric
we have to define the name of the metric
the goal and the Target now here you
could have for example like your
validation loss you have this metric
validation loss you could say you want
to optimize your parameters or you want
to choose the hyper parameters which
minimize the validation loss now you
could also change this into an accuracy
let's say validation accuracy adjust the
accuracy or just a train accuracy in
that case you want to choose the hyper
parameters which maximize the accuracy
and hence here at the level of the goal
you either minimize or maximize the
default is minimize so if you have a
validation loss it's needless specifying
the goal because by default it's
minimized and for now as in this
documentation there's really no
automatic way of deciding whether it's
minimize or maximize anyway you can
always do that manually by specifying
now the next we have is a target so here
with the target as you can see here for
example 0.95 it means that if you happen
to get a set of hyper parameters which
permit you get this
um validation accuracy to this target
value then at that point you will stop
the process of searching for the
optimal hyper parameters and what
happens exactly is all agents with
active rounds will finish their jobs but
no neurons will be launched in the sweep
since we've already attained the
objective from here we have early
terminate
which is an optional featured as piece
of hyper parameter search by stopping
poorly performing runs we get back here
copy out this code just copied okay copy
it we get back now to our hyper
parameter tuning to paste out the code
here and then we're just gonna try to
replicate what we have done already with
tensorboard so here we place this out
here and then we have this num units one
we have this number units one this year
and have that Nomine is one values
there we go let's copy this out and
paste here
so we replace these values which we had
already
and then the next will be num units two
it's kind of similar so we should
um nominus 2 okay so here we should just
copy this and paste right here num units
two
values yeah it's kind of similar okay we
have that and then there we go so we
have numbness one Nomine is two and then
the next drop out rate are we gonna have
learning rate so let's just have the
drop out right here so we have the drop
out rate and just drop our rate we take
values
um 0.1 to 0.3 now yeah what we're going
to use is like this mean Max so let's
just copy this out here
and then let's copy this out and then
paste it out here okay so we have
dropped our rate but yeah we're gonna go
from 0.1 to zero point let's say 0.4 and
this random actually is not greed so we
have that and then here okay name lesson
name malaria
prediction sweep
okay mental random parameters that's
fine so we're getting each and every
parameter now uh we have the drop R8 set
we now move to regularization rate
regularization rate
um value is 0.001 and 0.1
okay so we have 0.01 0.1 and then yeah
what we could do now is we make use of
let's say distribution and then we have
your uniform so we specify that we want
to make use of a uniform distribution
and then here so we're gonna uh use the
same again here for the learning rate
distribution
um uniform
there we go we have that uniform and
that's fine
a year we're going to go from this let's
say one
e negative four mean and then Max 1 E
negative two one e negative two okay so
looks good let's take this off now let's
take off our set here and then we have
that so from this we'll be able to
create now this sweep ID we'll get our
sweep ID by running this 1db sweep and
passing in the sweep configuration which
to run an agent the first step is we're
gonna Define a function to run the
training based on those hyper parameters
and then we're gonna pass that function
with the sweep ID here
in this 1db agent method so now let's
copy this code out and then paste it out
here this is out here and you'll also
notice that this is kind of like similar
to what we had done here because here we
had defined this method which takes in
the hyper parameters which we're trying
to tune and then we go through this
method here for each and every sweep
now let's get back here we have the
model we could simply make use of this
model so let's copy out some part let's
let's just copy out this here
let's copy that out and uh paste this
here paste it out and we have model tune
um learning model which we create here
hyper parameters and all of that and
then instead of what we had here where
we passed the we had to compile and the
feed method what will return your will
be just this model so we'll return the
Lynette model right here so let's have
this learn net model let's take all this
part of the code and that's fine okay so
we have this model tune here
um instead of make model we have model
tune and we'll pass the configuration in
here we add the project and the entity
in our init method
then we've modified this keys right here
to match with those of our 1db
configurations which we have seen
already let's get back here let's just
copy this and put right here so you
could see that
so as we could see instead of number of
units one we have number of dense one
and here we have number of dents too so
that's it we have the different values
you could take we have the drop out
the regularization rate and the learning
rate now
right here in this model this whole
model we should call model tune we shall
make use of this 1db configurations
which we've already passed in year and
so here we have config and
config and we're going to do the same
for all this other
different hyper parameters like your
would have number of filters your config
number of filters
and then you should note that
in this example we are not going to turn
all the hyper parameters so uh the hyper
parameters which we want to turn should
be in this parameter all parameters
dictionary in a sweep configuration the
method is random and the metric is the
accuracy with the goal of maximizing it
so if you want to tune any parameter or
hyper parameter you put that in here for
the rest we're just going to use
um this configurations which we've set
already so they'll just have some fixed
values so that said we would modify all
this
and there we go so we now have all these
different modifications we run this run
this and then back here or in the
subtrain
we could now replace all this with the
compilation and the
fit method
now again here I would have this
learning rate so we have
learning
rates
and then
um we could modify this number of epoch
to say three or actually the config so
we have config number of epochs
and you should know that we're carrying
this only on the validation set so you
could
try this on the full training data set
that will take much more time and also
you could feel free to carry out this
hyper parameter tuning on more
parameters so you could dig up say the
image size like this parameter here you
could add that up and then
see how this image size
affects the model performance so that
said we have all this already uh we have
our agent which takes the sweep ID which
we've defined already we have the
function which is the strain right here
and then we have this count which is the
number of runs to execute before you
proceed note that we specify this
configuration which is essentially this
configuration we have here so we could
just take this off and see this is our
configuration okay so that's our
configuration and now we're ready to
let our agents do their job so let's run
this
now after 20 runs here's what we get
start from here you see that starts by
picking the drop array the learning rate
the number of Dance One Number of dance
two and then the regularization rate
while obviously keeping the other
parameters constant here we have this
loss and its corresponding accuracy
and you could check out for the other
sweeps down here you see we have 20
different
um runs and we could get right here you
see and we click on this to view the
sweep
and now on this page you could see the
different runs we have here from one up
to 20 the epochs or rather the run the
accuracy and its corresponding loss and
then
uh we'll skip this two for now let's
look at this
we'll go ahead and check out the hyper
parameters which produce the highest
accuracy which is this year let's
highlight that we have this well let's
let's pick this out from here
um there we go we have this we have this
we have this
that comes down here we have this and
then we have this
and so here we have the hyper parameter
of values which give us the highest
accuracy score then coming into this
let's take this off
we could check out those different
parameters in our parameter importance
with respect to the accuracy so you see
that the most important is the learning
rate followed by the runtime number of
dense to drop our rate regulation rate
number of days one and here we have
this other hyper parameters which we did
not
um modify
now let's click on this here and see
what we have we told automatically show
uh shows the most useful parameters so
let's check this out
you see that after clicking on that the
other fixed hyper parameters and even
the runtime is taken off so we're left
with only this hyper parameters which we
had fixed
or better say which we had put in this
are sweep configuration
then one other point you could note from
here is this correlation to apart from
importance we could check out the
correlation and here we told that this
learning rate has a negative correlation
because you could see with the red the
red indicates negative correlation while
the green indicates positive correlation
so you could check out the value you see
this is 0.051 while this is negative
3.53 now what this symptom means is the
lower the learning rate then the higher
the accuracy and then just plot to the
left we have the accuracies for each and
every run
so that's it for the section thank you
for getting up to this point and see you
next time
hello everyone and welcome to this new
session in which World Trade data set
versioning with with some biases
if you've already used git for code
versioning then you should note that
this is kind of similar to what git does
as here we have this uh original theater
let's take this off we have this
original editor which is then
pre-processed
into this data year and then this other
pre-processed data of this pre-process
version is again pre-processed to give
us this one and then finally we have
this last step or this last
pre-processing step which gives us this
uh data set version which happens to be
an augmented data set version so this
shows us that if at any point in time we
are aren't satisfied with this
pre-processing which was done right here
to produce this dataset version we could
simply pre-process from uh making use of
this data set version right here and so
this gorilla simplifies our data set
management when working in a different
machine learning project just as gate
parameters do code versioning weights
and biasis gives us the possibility of
doing data set versioning and model
version and this can be done using
wasting bias artifacts which help us
save and organize machine learning data
sets throughout a Project's life cycle
we are going to start with the data set
versioning and the most common ways in
which waiting biases artifacts have been
used for dirty versioning R2 version
data seamlessly pre-packaged data splits
like training validation and test sets
iteratively refined data sets juggle
multiple data sets and finally visualize
and share data workflow before getting
into seeing how artifacts could be used
in this set versioning let's look at
this simple example in order to obtain
the malaria data set we have to start by
loading this data we have this data
loader which is represented by the
square and now once we've loaded this
data we have our data set so let's say
we have this original data set right
here we now go ahead to split this data
so from here we can split up this data
and then have the three different parts
we have the train data the validation
data and the test data at this point all
three did it sets and I've been passed
in this pre-processing units right here
so we pre-process the Train pre-process
the validation and pre-process the test
and this gives us an output here so for
the training we have a pre-processed
training data here we have this
pre-process training data we have this
pre-processed validation data and then
here we have also this pre-processed
test data again at this point we are now
going to carry out augmentation on this
pre-processed training data this ptrd
means pre-process this pre-processed
training data and then pre-process
validation data preprocess testing later
okay so we have that and then we pass
this through this
augmentation process so we have this
process which rule without of carrying
out data augmentation on this data set
to produce another
data set which is actually now an
augmented version of this so here we
have a pre-processed training data now
we have augmented training data and this
is kind of like the life cycle of a data
set and this particular problem in which
we're working on imagine that this
original data set contained misleveled
examples in that case what you want to
do is now to carry out this labeling
correctly such that we have this data
set here which now has been cleaned
overall those list two a higher level of
accountability as when working on a team
and let's say you've done some
modification let's say you have cleaned
the theater all the people in your team
can now view those cleaned data set and
decide whether to modify it deleted or
keep using it so if we suppose the other
team accepts this clean data set and
everyone is happy with this newly
cleaned data set we now see that instead
of passing this directly into the split
we will now pass but this one into the
speed
so it would have something like this
we'll go this way let's take this off
in that case we would have to go this
way
we go this way
this and then into the speed and then
talking about data set versioning for
each and every data set we've created
here like for this one this one this
this this this this this or this one we
have different versions so we could have
for example this PVD here that is the
pre-processed validation data uh and it
could have a version zero or version o
so we have the version o right yeah and
then later on you may modify this
pre-processing and it leads us to have
another version of this validation data
so you could have another version
version one and the version version two
and the version you could see version
best you can have version latest
and so on and so forth
and a good thing is when Waiting by us
or when using wisdom buyers to store
this theater or when we using a wasting
by artifacts
the theater start in such a way that if
we have data in this original data set
which is exactly the same as what we
have in this pre-processed validation
data
then that data wouldn't be duplicated
now it's true that if we process this
data obviously we'll have um all the
data set all the elements of the data
set changing now let's take this example
in the for the clean data set so here
we've had we have this original data set
let's suppose we have say we have 10 we
have 10 different examples
different samples in this original data
set and then after cleaning our data set
only two of these samples have been
modified so we have eight unmodified and
two modified so we have modified we have
changed the levels
of these two samples here what Wilson
bias will do is it will ensure that this
eight-year aren't duplicated that is we
don't create extra space for those eight
others which haven't changed from this
previous original data set year and so
in that case we're gonna only store this
two new samples here while waiting
biases keeps track of the fact that this
other eight samples haven't been
modified and so don't necessarily need
to occupy extra space in the storage
unit which with symbiases makes
available for us for free that said we
could look at those different processes
right here those processes in the square
boxes as 1 DB runs while this different
forms and even the versions which are
data takes are the artifacts and so we
could consider this key here where this
represents artifacts and thus the runs
also we see that the artifacts are
connected together by these different
runs so this two artifacts this train
data and the original Little set has
been connected together by this split
run and then this two ptrd and Trend
theater are connected together by the
pre-processing Run getting back to the
documentation we'll see how we create
this artifact here which is called the
new data set of type raw data and then
this is created within this run right
here so we see how we create this run
and specify the project my project and
once we create this artifact we're gonna
add data into it now one thing you could
do with 1db is you could simply add a
whole directory so we suppose that all
your data is a given directory and so
you just all you need to do is specify
this path and then you make this dinner
part of this 1db artifacts which we've
called my data and then finally you lock
this artifact to 1db Let's copy out this
sample code paste it out here we have
that sample code and then we could get
started with our data set versioning now
we are going to put this in a with
statement so we have here with 1db init
and then we'll specify the project
project we're working on which is this
malaria detection project The Entity
neural learn and that's it so we have
this year and then we are going to
create our original leader so we have
original theater there we go we are
going to create this artifact actually
we have that original leader only be
artifact new this set type raw dealer
now to check out on the different
arguments we could pass in here get back
to documentation
um let's check out here and then uh you
could scroll down so here you have this
references
let's reduce this and have this clearly
we have references on the references you
have this python library and then you
have 1db artifact so you could click on
this and what do you get you have this
documentation right here so we have the
different arguments name type
description metadata incremental and use
us now note that this for uh optional so
that's why in the example we just had
the name and the type we'll now add up
this here we have name and then type and
we have description with a metadata so
let's have this description right here
description simply we could say malaria
data set or tensorflow
tensorflow malaria data set so that's it
for the descriptions actually a string
and then we have this metadata which is
this dictionary which contains
information related to our data set so
here we Define this dictionary we're
gonna stop for example the source so we
could have your source and then we say
TF data set okay so we have that Source
we could also add other information from
this home page so let's even copy out
this description here and then paste it
out here so in the place of this
description we have that and there we go
that's fine now we'll check out on the
home page we have home page source code
let's copy this out and paste out here
and now we have all this necessary
metadata information so here is it we've
created this artifact we then paste out
this code which we had seen previously
and which permissions load the malaria
data set from tensorflow data set and
then we'll save this data set in the
numpy compressed format so with our
original
data which is this one year this
artifact dot new file new file so unlike
here where we add directory here we add
in our we're creating this new file
which now contains this data set so with
original data.new file we'll call it
original
data dot npz so that's our file name and
then the mode is going to be a right
mode and we have this as file so we have
this artifact we add this new file with
a file name and then we save this file
while putting in the appropriate content
so right here we have NP save Z that's
our compressed format okay here we have
NPC and then here we have this file and
then what we pass in is our data set
which is this one and so at this point
with reading uh information or this data
set in this artifact and then we're now
ready to lock this so here we have of
Rhonda log artifacts this basically this
year so let's let's do this let's take
this off we have there we go we have run
the log artifact and then what we're
passing in here is original
data okay so that's it so now we've seen
how to
um create this run and in this round we
have this artifacts and then we put in
the information in the artifact now one
thing we could do is put all this in a
method so we'll Define the method load
um original data so we load the original
data and simply does it so let's send
this one step and that's fine there we
go so we have that load original data
method defined let's add this code cell
and then we can call it right here so we
can call load original theater and there
we go so let's get back to this diagram
we had previously you'll see that in
this diagram if we take off
um if you don't consider this path that
is information flows this way and then
gets split and so on and so forth so
here what we have is we've had this load
original data method which takes into
consideration there's two here we have
this run which is the dead loader so we
have the little run and then what it
does is it recuperates this original
data set from tensorflow data sets and
then produces an artifact which is this
one now so the artifact we have just
created here this artifact original
theater is this which is we had drawn
previously here we then run the cell and
load the original data we get this
output unfortunately this process has
failed let's check out the reason why
this field cannot convert a tensor of
d-type variance to a numpy array
now since this variable data set we have
here is of D type variant what we're
gonna do is we're gonna take out each
and every element of this data set
and save it in a directory so from here
we're going to copy out this code let's
copy out this code and paste it out here
Mac and now what we have in here is
we're gonna go through this data set so
we have for D in data set of auditor for
later in data set now we have a list
here and then we could pick out the zero
element so pick up the zero element and
then for that we are going to create
this folder that is set right here so
let's have this new folder and call it
data set okay so we have that new photo
data set in that photo data set we are
going to put in this different tensors
which are going to be stored in this
numpy compressed format so that's it we
have this we modify the name so let's
say we we have malaria malaria data set
and then we give it a number so let's
have that plus we'll give it a number
plus this so here now we have this K we
initialize K and then we're gonna
continually be incrementing this key so
here we have now malaria data set we
have k k and then we have this extension
right here so that's how we're gonna
save this file and then the data we're
going to be saving is going to be this
so we have data which we're going to be
saving in each and every one of this
file now let's test this out and let's
put out a break here so we see exactly
what we'll be getting We Run The Cell
original data now defined we also need
to do open here so we're going to open
this file and then save that let's run
this again we check out now this
directory we have your data set and
there we go you see we have this
information here saved now let's run
this for all the data set so let's take
out the break and then run this let's
print out
K and then like after a thousand steps
so if k modulo a thousand a thousand
equals zero we should print out K okay
so let's run again we have now all this
data locked let's take off this one now
and then get back to documentation and
you you have my data at directory there
so you're passing the directory right
there so from here we have now instead
original theater dot add directory and
then we're gonna pass in the directory
which in those cases did is set so we
have that this had passed we don't
really need to have this again so we
could take that off okay so that's it uh
everything looks fine let's now run this
cell right here we run that and run this
and this time around the artifact is
loaded successfully so now we are going
to check out you know dashboard and here
you'll see that we have this
um raw dinner you did set and then you
have this versions two different
versions of this new data set we have
version 0 and version one now you click
on this version one you should be able
to have this let's check out the
overview you see you have this data set
malaria data set on all this in fact
there's a meta data we put in already so
that's it we have this API we're going
to come back to this actually because to
use this artifact we're making use of
this API then we check out on metadata
we have this metadata which we logged in
we should put in in the notebook we have
the files you see those different files
here
this directory uh you see you have the
root and then you have basically all
those files now you have this graph view
which for now is very simple so here you
have a run the runs actually this run
here so this run and then we have this
artifact which has been created now this
artifact contains the raw data and so we
could click on explode and basically
that's it yeah you have the name of this
run Vivid water name of the run and then
the data is this new data set and it's
version one and then the next thing we
want to do is to move to the next step
that is be able to split this data set
into this order into three different
parts now what we could do other than
this is we process this before during
the splitting so we don't have to do
this pre-processing tries so instead of
having this let's take this off here
we'll modify this search that here's
what we now obtain so coming back to
this we have this run and this artifact
which our audio set is basically what we
have here and then the next step will be
to pre-process this so we'll do the
pre-processing on our data set and then
produces pre-processed data and then
from here we'll now do this pleading we
have this run which whose row will be
the split our data into the training
validation and testing and then for the
training we'll have another run which
row will be to do augmentation on a
training data so in fact in summary this
is what we want to achieve like when
we're done with all this we want to have
a graph view which looks like this we
now go straight forward into the
pre-processing let's copy it we get back
to the code that's fine we paste this
out here we then put this in a with thin
man and then run this code and here's
what we get we've now downloaded this 27
000 files we check out your and we
should have this artifacts new data set
version one and you see we have all
those files which we unlocked in
previously so now this means that the
next time you want to work on this data
set you don't really need to come around
this year like we don't need to run this
again so we don't have to do this again
all we need to do now is just to use
this artifact with with some biases
starts for us and so now that we have
this we'll get back here and then we do
this resize reskill practically our
processing here is resizing and
rescaling so we're gonna do resize and
every skill of all uh images you can
copy this and then get back to where we
actually have loaded our artifacts when
we print this out we have those path to
our different files so we would have
your artifacts we can check out all
those files here and and right now we're
gonna create this other run so let's
copy this out and then have the space
that year now here we have this
pre-process
pre-process the data so this is this
method we're going to be defining one to
be innate project entity as well we've
created this new run and then we have
now this pre-processed data
pre-processed data which is now this new
artifact and the name is
pre-processed
pre-processed data set and then the type
is pre-processed data
we have our pre-processed leader okay
description would say a
pre-processed version
of the malaria data set of the malaria
set let's take this off and then for the
metaditer we could let's take let's take
all this off let's have this taken off
but you could always put information
above the middle leader we are now going
to go through each and every file we
have in this uh directory here so we'll
have four
file in let's say for f for f in OS dot
list Dar of this
um directory here let's copy this from
here so we're gonna list we're gonna
create a list from this directory and we
go through this list so we go through
this list and then for each and every
file in this list what we'll be doing is
open up that file so here you have
artifact directory which we've just
defined and then we have this out of our
directory plus F to specify the current
file and then we read that file as file
so from here now once we've read this as
file we have X Y outputs we call this
our output so for each file since each
file we had has an X and A Y will take
this from here and then we have this
load file now once we have this we're
gonna have X or better still X full
that's X data so let's let's call this X
data set all data set data set X so we
have our data set X
dot append we're gonna create this as a
list so we have here data set x a list
and then we have data set Y and not a
list so that's it we've created this two
lists and then we want to take each and
every element and append it to this data
set X and data set y respectively here
we have for x and then we have data set
y the append y now recall what we have
to pre-process as this is our
pre-processing method so here we have
this resize let's make sure we run this
resize for skill and it takes in the
image all it takes an X basically so
here we have resize rescale instead of
passing X we'll do resize rescue
and then we pass in X now we ensure that
we Define this in size let's have the
same size defined here M size equal to
24. run that again that should be fine
we need to also specify the fact that it
will allow pickle here so we have this
argument which is 10 to true you could
always check out the documentation right
here
and then from here we are not going to
take this directly yeah what we get is
npz array
and then to obtain X and Y we have
X
and Y
which is equal NP Z array we get the
numpy array and we get the values
so that's what we do to get this you
could always check on documentation to
understand how all this MP load and all
of this work now once you have X and Y
this is what we pass in here so from
here we can run this this looks fine we
have our data set and that's okay but
before running we have to ensure that we
convert this now into a tensorflow data
set so let's get this done by having
this is called data set
and we have TF theater
data set from tensor slices and then
what we're going to pass in here is The
Descent X and data set y now we're going
to be saving this as a file so we're
gonna take out this and we have this uh
portion of this code right here which is
going from the documentation so here we
have with artifact the artifact here is
pretty
processed is pre-processed later so we
pre-processed later the new file we
specify all the file name let's call
this a pre
-processed data set as file we then save
this with numpy we have NP that save Z
in the compressed format we specify the
file and the data to be saved in this
case all data is just data set right
here which is this tensorflow data set
this looks okay we can now do
long artifact
pre-processed
deals or rather pre-processed data then
before running we are going to take out
just a part of all this data set so
we'll take out only a thousand elements
and the reason why we're doing this is
because we do not have enough memory to
store the two to two thousand uh 500 20
500 different data points as a single
variable so we'll have that for now
let's have this 1000 elements so you
could see how this is done now if you
have a real world problem where you have
say a hundred thousand different
elements or a hundred thousand different
data points then you could break them up
into simpler parts so here we have that
a thousand we speak we take out just a
thousand and then one thing we'll do is
copy out this part here we'll copy out
this part and then include it in this
run so before just before this so we
include this here in this run and the
fact that you include this in this run
will link up this new data set with a
pre-processed data set now that's set we
could run this and then run the next
cell what we get is this error saying
cannot convert a tensor of D type
variance to a numpy array so here we are
having this tensor of d-type variant and
we're trying to store it as a numpy
array and to solve this problem now what
we'll do is we'll just ignore this and
then save the data set X and Y as this
list we have data set X and it is set y
so let's run this now and pre-process
our data
we now have successfully locked this to
our artifact let's get to our dashboard
1db dashboard let's refresh this page
here you'll see your artifacts you could
click on artifacts modular detection
artifacts and then you could select from
this so this is what we had previously
this new data set under this raw editor
now if we process there we have this
pre-processed data set and this is our
most recent version that we go you could
check out the files you see this file
right here metaditer API which you could
use now to do or carry out all
operations uh the overview graph view
this all graph view right here now let's
explode this graph view okay we have
exploded this graph view let's Zoom okay
now you'll see that let's drag this one
here and then what you'll notice is we
have this first pad which has to do with
the creation or rather with the loading
of our initial original data set and
then once we load this original data set
that the next thing we did was to now
pre-process this data set now we'll
carry out other runs previously that's
why you have this so you don't really
need to take this into consideration
from here we just consider continue from
this uh Point here we copy out this API
here we have that copy and then we get
back to our code where we're gonna start
now where the data is splitting space is
out here you see that we're gonna have
uh we've already had two artifacts
created one was original data the other
the pre-process data the next will be
the trend theater validation data and
test data and so that's why we call this
a section the data splitting we'll again
copy out this part from the word
processing data and paste here
now we have this let's go ahead and take
this off from here and then replace this
one here we have this artifact
okay we have this artifact now which is
all the RFI we're using now is processed
data set and then from here we have
three artifacts which we're going to
create we have three data uh we'll just
call this train data set train data set
type let's say it's pre-process data
description trading data set and then
the artifact directory we could get it
from this year so when we create this
artifacts we're gonna get this artifact
directory for now let's just create the
other artifacts so we copy this out
train leader we have validation theater
and then the test data to obtain the
artifact directory we're gonna run this
we have this output here click on those
artifacts and see we have this process
data set which has been loaded and we
have our prep
dataset.npz file here so this here we
copy this path and then at the place of
this artifact directory we're going to
place this path let's take this off
we have this path now which has been
placed we have now the artifact let's
call this artifact
file and then
let's place this out here
take this off
and there we go
we've now taken all this off
okay so we have this here
and then we're gonna have our
artifact file instead fastier uh effect
file so we read that as file and then
we're gonna load this file allow pickle
and get the array
then at this point we Define the trading
split valve speed and test bleed from
here we're gonna place this out we have
our train array because we're trying to
create this three different arrays we
have train array which goes takes values
from zero to the transpeat
we'll Define a data length later length
which is the length of array
zero now recall that the array the array
we have in
this array is made of this is at least
actually made of two parts the X and the
Y this x has a length of a thousand the
Y at the end of a thousand that's why
we're doing array the zeroth index of
array and then we're taking its length
so here we're gonna get the length to a
value of a thousand and once we have
this data length now we're saying that
we're picking out those X
we're picking out this x right here and
then we're taking values from zero to
eighty percent of the total length and
so we have train split which is 0.8
Times theater length
so that's what we have
and then we repeat the same for this y
then for the validation array we're
going to start from this train splits
we're going to start from here times
that so from the 80th
index with respect to the total data set
that's where multiplying by the data
length we're going to go from here right
up to
the transplate plus the validation split
so now we're going to form 0.8 to 0.9
and we have that set we'll just repeat
this for the validation for the Y right
here so let's copy this out
we'll copy this out
and then paste this here
that looks fine we have that paste that
we have it here and this here
this looks fine let's repeat the same
process for the test array copy this and
paste out your test array we're going to
go from
transplate plus vowel split right up to
the end so we're going from 0.8 uh plus
0.1 that's 0.9 times total of the length
from the 900th value right to the end we
just copy this again out here
copy that out and then paste this for
the Y value
so we have this here take this off paste
it and then we go right to the end so
that looks fine again we have now our
train array validation array and test
array we're now set to write this
information and now
artifacts so here we have a width
pre-processed data this is instead now
with train there we call our artifact we
just created your stream data train data
validator and test data so we Trend
theater the new file we have our we'll
call this train it is set dot npz mode
WB save the file and then we are saving
train what was seven years actually just
train array so we're just saving the
strain array and then we repeat the same
process for the validation and the
testing okay we have that validation
validation
test test and then here we have test
okay we have okay here we have
validation and then yeah two we have
test
then now we log all different artifacts
so we not only log in this one artifact
but the three different artifacts stick
this back and then yeah we log Trend
theater
train theater
Val data
and test theater okay we have that set
we could run this let's let's change it
to split data we run this cell here
everything looks fine and then we move
on to split all data split data we run
that cell and wait for the response
here's the Apple we get now the reason
why we're having this is because we must
have integers and not floats at this
level so when we have this indices we
have to convert this all into integers
so we have this interior there we go int
and
from here we now run this cell again and
then split all theater the editor has
now been split successfully let's get
back to our dashboard right here we have
our 1db dashboard
artifacts let's refresh this page as you
could see we have our data preprocessed
data and now we have the test data
validation data and our train better
let's click open this training theater
so you could look at a file here metal
deter API we can always make use of this
in creating other artifacts and let's
get to the graph view in this graph view
now we'll be able to see the link
between this uh original data set the
pre-process data and the train data set
here's what we get let's click on
explode and you can see this clearly now
so here you see you have this original
the settings artifact here we have this
run which produces this data pre-process
artifact and then we have this run which
produce since this trained data set
validation data set and test data set so
let's draw this take this off uh we have
this path here you see we have this here
we take this this and this let's copy
out of this code right here and then
start with the data augmentation so from
here we now download the train data set
we could check this out in our artifacts
you should have trained data set right
here there we go we have our training
the set we can now copy this part let's
um copy this path and paste here now we
could click on this one to be finished
to stop that run and that should be fine
now let's go ahead and copy out this
part of the code which was used for
pre-processing so yeah we have this here
pre-processed data we copy this and then
there we go let's paste this here we
have our augment bidder and then project
artifacts we're gonna use this artifacts
here so let's come right here and then
get this path
okay so we we're gonna get that path and
then replace this one with this up on
part or the pad to the training data set
the space is out and this should be fine
this is actually a file so we have
artifact file now we have this take this
off
pre-process data instead of preprocessed
data we're going to use augmented Arc
minted dealer want to be artifact
augmented data set
augmented
data set type let's say process data uh
an augmented version
augmented version
of the malaria train data set so
everything looks fine for now we have
that and then here let's get back to
this and then copy out this year
and then paste this right here so we're
getting this from our training dealer
obviously there we go
and everything looks fine next thing to
do is do the actual augmentation and
then lock the data set to our artifact
so let's take this back and then we take
this off now we have this we open up
this artifact file right here artifact
file we open that up we obtain our array
let's call it array then for
for images or for image in the array or
array oh we're taking out the X so for
emission X before moving on we're going
to create this m to list here data set X
and then we have that okay we have data
set X and then this exit the pen augment
of whatever image will pass in let's
send this one step and that's fine so
for all images we are going to do this
augmentation then after this we have
data set Y which is simply the unchanged
levels we've had already so from here
now we have all that is at X and R data
set y then we can now run the cell and
then we run the augment data we have
here augment editor and this should be
fine we obtain those error pre-processed
data now defined so let's check back
here and we see that this should be
augmented data instead so let's change
this and we have augmented data there we
go we run this cells and see what we get
now those artifacts have been locked
successfully we could get to 1db and
check this out here we have this and
then we click on augmented data set so
loading the artifacts
now let's loaded let's click on this and
check out on this graph so let's explode
and then this is what we have now so you
see again that we have this path we have
our data we separate this or split this
into train validation and testing you
see here you have the training
validation and testing and then after
the training we have this run which
converts this training data into an
augmented data which is this one right
here
and so at this point we have different
versions of our data which we could make
use of depending on our needs thank you
for getting around to this point and see
you next time
hello everyone and welcome to this new
session in which we'll treat model
version with 1db now in the previous
session we had looked at dataset
versioning in which we had created an
augmented version of our data which
happens to be this version right here
from previous versions like a
pre-processed version another
pre-processed version and the original
theater
and so from here
we are now gonna see how to implement
model versioning using this augmented
data and the untrained model version so
we have this version of the model which
is untrained and the augmented Theater
which are going to be passed in this run
to produce are trained model version in
the previous session we saw how to
implement data set versioning with 1db
artifacts we left from this original raw
data right here onto this pre-processed
data we created a trained validation and
test sets and then finally we had this
augmented data right here and now we are
gonna see how to make use of this
augmented data in trainer model but
while training this model we are gonna
Implement model versioning and the two
model versions will have here will be
the model before training and the model
after training and so we're making use
of this sequential model which we had
created previously and the good news
here is the way we Implement model
versioning is quite similar to The Way
We Implement data set versioning we'll
start by copying out this code and then
we'll simply modify that and here we
have this 1db model versioning let's
place that out and then here instead of
augment editor we are gonna log out
model so here we have log
model which is in fact this Linette
model right here we have the lock model
wannabe needs our project entity
specified the artifacts
to be used Here is known so you're not
gonna make use of any artifact to lock
this model artifact right here and so
with that we have this take off this
augmented data we have our model that's
called
model or untrained untrained model
and then we specify that it is this
untrained model
it's of type model so we have that type
model
the initial version of our Lunette model
there we go now we have this done uh
this artifact file here we're not going
to make use of this we're not making use
of any previous artifacts we just log in
this model initially and then here
we'll take this off we're not going to
make use of this
just before writing in our model we're
going to save that model so here we have
this model to be saved we call it's all
in that model actually so we have
learned model.save
and then we'll give it a file name so
let's call it
lunet.h5 and that's it so we'll save
this model
let's have this file name to be Lunette
ish5 so let's define this lunet H5 file
here and take this off
so we have now our file name
now since we've already saved this file
instead of going through this process
here I've created a new file and all of
that we're just going to add a file so
here we have our untrained model dot add
file and then we'll specify the file
name so that's all we need to do and
then we're gonna also do 1db dot save
that file based on the file name that's
it so let's take off this part here and
then we're gonna log our artifact which
happens to be our untrained model so we
have your untrained model and that's
fine now we could add in some metadata
so let's have meta data which is equals
our configuration which we've defined
already and here let's modify this name
this is uh untrained model so here's
untrained model and that's fine so with
this we could now run this year
with this successful run right here and
then we can now go back to 1db getting
back here we have this under our
artifacts we have the model so yeah we
could click on this model and then we
specify the untrained model so let's
click on this and we have this overview
you see we have that API metadata see
the metadata we've logged in we have the
files you see here the Lynnette model
and then we have as usual our graph view
which we could explode notice that it's
quite simple because for now it isn't
linked to our data set so all we have is
just this run which produces this
untrained model or this initialized
model
from this point we'll go ahead to train
our model and lock that trained version
of the model so again here we have this
artifact which we're gonna use in
training the model which happens to be
our augmented data set we call that we
had lock this augmented data previously
you could have this overview from here
we have this augmented data set and then
uh it's of type pre-processed data we've
seen that already we downloaded data and
then we create this new artifact which
is going to be our trained sequential
model we call this trained
sequential model soft type model
description a trained version of our
model simple as that so that's it we
could also pass in The Meta data just as
oh we had senior with this log model
where we pass in the configuration so
metadata equals our configuration
and that's fine getting back to this
augment data meta we have seen
previously we are going to follow this
same pattern that is we're gonna
download the editor as we've done
already we download the data and then we
have this artifact file here the
artifact file we're using was a trained
data set because we needed to take this
and convert it into augmented data set
and then we had this processing right
here to produce dataset X and data set y
now we're gonna do this exact Presidio
for training our data on the augmented
data so let's paste this out right here
and then your artifact file will be this
Arc data set so here we have Arc data
set and we get this
um right from here let's get back to our
set files and there we go you see we
have this Arc data set npz which will
start previously and so once we are
going to download this we're gonna have
this file which is going to be found in
this folder which is also found in this
artifacts photo so we have artifacts
augmented data set version 0 which is
from this this means that if you want to
use the version one we just simply have
to specify your version one and so on
and so forth so that's that we have our
artifact file data set and then we go
through this processing to obtain data
set X and data set y
and then from here we'll go through this
series of steps to convert this data
into a tensorflow data set type data so
here we have the x d y this this is an X
we convert to tensor so we convert this
data set X to a tensor and then set y to
a tensor then from here we apply this
from tensor slices method which takes in
DX and d y that's how this is an X and
uh they just hit Y to create this uh new
data set D now we go to the same
procedures we've seen already that we
Shuffle we batch we prefetch and then we
have our training data set now note that
you could repeat the same process for
the validation but here we'll just do
this for the training and you could take
it as an exercise to do the same for the
validation note that for validation we
didn't make use of the augmented data
set we instead made use of the
validation data set itself let's get to
the graph view so you could see that
clear
and as you could see here we have this
uh data which is pre-processed
pre-processed data Trend data set
pre-posited data the validation data set
we process data test data set and then
from here we had the augmented data
which is this one and so
when you want to carry out validation
you're not going to be making use of
this training data obviously so we're
going to make use of this one instead
and so if you are to
put in the validation in here that's
convert the validation data into a
tensorflow data set time dinner and then
use it for training and uh evaluation
then you would have to make sure you
modify this year
so that said we continue with this
process we have the trend dealer which
we've just created is now a tensorflow
data set time data and so
training can now go on smoothly so you
see here we have the metrics we've used
to seeing this already uh compiling and
then we fit the model so yeah we're not
going to include the validation
uh we have that ready we're gonna do the
training and after training our model we
would have this so let's let's simply
just have that learned model.fit and
then after this we'll have similar to
what we had seen already here in this
log model method the file which has been
saved and then
saved to 1 DB and then the artifact
which has been locked so let's copy this
out and then get back here and paste
this now let's change its name let's say
Lunette trained Lunette trained that's
our file name on train model dot add
file it's actually here we have this
trained sequential model so let's have
this as trained
sequential
model
there we go we have the train sequential
model or add file file name one DBC file
name run the log artifact the trained
sequential model trained sequential
model okay so that's it so we have this
set we could now run this method and
then see what we get we obtain this
error where we've been told the name
Lunette model isn't defined now as you
had seen previously with this log model
method we made use of the Lynette model
which we had defined right here so we
Define this Lynnette model as a using
the sequential API and that's what we
had and this led us to having this year
where we had a run so initially we had
this run which produced our untrained
model so we have this year on trained
model let's call it um on-train model
and since in our case we're trying to
build our train model is gonna be reason
for us to make use of this untrained
model which we've started already in 1db
since we're doing model versioning and
so instead of us making use of this
Lynette model we are going to make use
of this version of the untrained model
which will start already in 1db so from
here we're gonna run another process
which now will lead us to this trained
model but then to run this process we'll
also need deer so as you could see you
have the data that's augmented dinner uh
from here we have the train dealer we
have different other notes which came
before this so we call our we've seen
before having the untrained the
augmented data which is this one year
and then this augmented dinner together
with this untrained model will produce
our train model and once we have the
stream model we can now use it for
prediction and so come and back again if
we had to use this Lunette model which
was defined here in the notebook would
have the this this data set I will have
our data which will pass into the run
and then we'll have our output at train
model
and then on the other side we'll just
have this output at like we have this
run and then we have this outputed
untrained model so we have the untrained
model and the train model we should
exist like two separate entities in our
Global graph whereas what we want to do
is be able to link this to up and so
that's why we are not going to make use
of this London model which was defined
here and this is why we're gonna make
use of the model which has already been
stored in 1db that said getting back to
the code we're going to copy this out
here and then in the place of this
linear model as
um in instead of using the linet model
we'll Define we've defined here we are
now going to make use of our artifact we
should start already so let's let's have
this here so let's have that pasted here
and then we'll make use of this
artifacts which is in fact called
the untrained model so you see we have
this year let's copy this out we copy
that out and then we paste this year
let's paste this here
and there we go just after downloading
the model The Next Step will be to have
this artifact file which is simply our
untrained model which we should have
done which we should have downloaded so
in that case we're gonna have this your
artifacts Stone artifacts directory
artifacts and then in here we stick this
out from here let's copy this and paste
out here on Trend model and then to be
more specific we could get the file name
from here so here you see we have the
file name you could get back here
overview and then you have files lunet
H5 so this is a file we're gonna
download and here is it your so we have
that so now we have the artifact file
which we want to download we have this
path and then now we could make use of
tensorflows
load model method so here we have now
Lunette model which is equal
tf.kiras models and load model which
takes in the artifacts file there we go
so now we have this Lunette model which
is not gotten from this definition here
but which is getting from a previous
version of our model which has been
stored in 1db so let's now run this and
see what we get after training for over
three ebooks your other results we get
and then we get to 1 DB you see here we
have the model trained sequential model
and then the all-train model so let's
click on this trend sequential model
loading artifacts there we go we could
look at this API metadata which we
loaded and the file so here we have
Lynette trained and then we also have
our graph View
explode in this view here's what we get
now let's focus on this part here and as
you can see we have this run which
produces this untrained model year we
have this on train model and then this
untrained model together with our
augmented data set been passed through
this run now produce our trained
sequential model and that's it for the
section in which we've seen how to
implement model versioning with 1db
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session
in this session we shall be building a
system which permits us automatically
detect weather and input
which in this case is an image is that
of an angry happy or sad person so this
person may be sad as you could see here
the person may be angry
as you could see here all the person may
be happy
so in fact we want to be able to have
this kind of input pass it into our
system which we want to build and then
automatically infer that this is a happy
person
and so to train the system we'll be
making use of this data set which has
been made Available To Us by Muhammad
Hanan asgar
and since this data set is available on
Kegel just anyone could have access to
it we are now going to take a closer
look at this data set as you could see
here we have this test and train
directories you open up the train uh
open up the test you see you have these
three different folders angry happy sad
here for the train you have Angry happy
sad too so what we do is generally when
trying to create this kind of data set
for classification problems what you
want to do is make sure that you put
each or you put the different images in
separate directories so all images are
representing angry people are in this
directory happy in this directory and
sad in this directory now this way
becomes easy for us to build our model
taking this data set as input also on
the previous sessions we explained the
reason why it's very important for us to
split our data set in this kind of
manner
such that while you use part of the data
set that's the training to actually
train or build your model you're going
to use the other part to evaluate this
model
so although in this case we've just been
given this data which is a very unlike
what you have in real world scenarios
where you'll be
asked or test to build your own data set
like this
one thing or one very important thing
you have to note is the fact that if for
example your buildings kind of data set
where say we want to monitor the usage
of an app or better steel monitor how
the users of an app
react to a certain feature then it's
important to get a data that reflects
all
is very similar to what the data or the
rather what the model will be seen
during inference
and so this means that
if you have this kind of data or if your
model is going to be seeing this kind of
data during the inference or when it's
gonna make use of the model to predict
whether there's a happy image or not
then
training on this kind of data
isn't a good idea although this is uh
images or these are images of happy
people so
you have to ensure that the data you
train on is representative of the data
or the kinds of inputs the model will be
seen when
it's going to be deployed and left
to predict or make predictions from
these kinds of images
then if you have noticed not all classes
we have here have the same number of
files so here you have a happy a
thousand angry 500 sad
757 for the train is uh one five two
five year three thousand uh set two two
five five so this shows us that
when solving your real world problems it
may happen that some class or it's
easier to gather ditter from a
particular class as compared to the
other so your
maybe the order of this data set found
it easier to gather happy images as
compared to angry images
another very important point to another
year is the fact that the kind of
problem we're trying to solve is that of
multi-class classification so unlike
previously where we had a model we had
some data which went passed in uh we
would say weather this is a parasitic or
non-parasitic input cell
whereas here
what are model outputs isn't just either
one class or the other but
a model which outputs a given class out
of several options now those options
could be three four five six seven or
even 1000 different possibilities now
all the different possibilities are
termed classes so in this case we have
three classes the first class is that of
the angry person the next class happy
person the other class Assad person now
to be able to download this data the
very first thing we want to do is create
this new API token right here so you get
to your profile you click on account and
you'll have this year click here
and save this cargo.json file so we'll
get that saved
then getting back to the collab notebook
we simply copy this in here
okay
and then we should have this here now
before moving on it's important to note
that you will have to sign up for cargo
account
and then the next tab will be to install
this Kegel
package so pip install
Kegel run that cell
then we create this directory so we'll
make this directory and then we copy
this Json file in this directory so
again we run the cell
then from here we give the user full
rise to read and write into this cargo
file right here we run the cell
then get back to Kegel where we are
going to copy this API command
now after copying this API command we're
gonna paste this just here so here we
have kaggle data sets download so we're
going to download this data set this
human emotions data set let's run the
cell
our data set has been downloaded now
we're now left to unzip this downloaded
file let's click this here you see we
have human emotions data set that zip we
now unzip this and store in this data
set folder so you're going to run this
cell you'll see that it's going to
create this folder this set and in this
data set you have the emotions data set
which you saw in Kegel basically there's
the data set right here from this point
we'll go on to generate a tensorflow
data set based off the images which are
found in the directories so we're going
to make use of this image data set from
directory method which is in the Keras
utils
package right here so here we have this
description here we have this different
arguments directory now the directory
let's let's copy this so we see clearly
this in the code we copy and paste this
out here this directory is going to be
simply uh one of these directories here
so your first thing we'll do is we'll
create our train data set so that's our
Trend date is set which is a tensorflow
data set we've seen this already uh
we're gonna specify the directory so
let's call this uh train directory
and would simply copy this path so let's
copy this path
and then paste it out here copy that
path paste it now we have
our validation validation directory
we're gonna do the same thing so
basically again we're going to copy this
here
uh copier and paste now here we're gonna
use this as our Trend data set and we're
gonna use this as our validation data
set so yeah so train here's a validation
and that's it so with this let's run
this cell that's it we get back here we
change this to train
directory now here the levels are
inferred
and this means that the labels will be
generated from the directory structure
so if you could look at this here
um this example let's okay you have this
main directory and you have the
direction structure that's why at the
beginning uh we may mention of the fact
that it's important to maintain this
kind of Direction structure when doing
with classification problems so because
we have this kind of directive structure
where we have a class
we have as images we have another class
and then it's images like we could see
here we have this uh in the train we
have the class we have the images we
have this class and this images this
class and its images we are able to
automatically create this kind of data
set
and that's the role of this inferred
right here then the next one we have is
a level mode now for the level mode we
have several modes uh here the default
we have the int we have categorical we
have binary unknown now let's explain
what these different modes mean for the
integer mode we're simply meaning that
when we design or the way we design our
data set is such that we have an image
and we have a level so let's say we have
this image of this person the person is
happy
and we have three different
possibilities either
the person is angry
happy or sad
so you're
what we're gonna have is Angry Angry
we're gonna give it a value of zero
happy a value of one sad a value of two
so here are all three different
possibilities and so when designing this
data set or when creating this data set
we'll create a search that we have the
image and this integer which reflects
what that uh the emotion in that image
so here in our case in the case of happy
would simply have an output of one
now that said either we create our data
set in this way or we use a one-hard
representation of this levels so what
this means is instead of having a zero
we'll create a vector of size 3 which
has three different positions where if
we have a an angry input so if the
person is angry we'll put a 1 on this
position and zero zero year if the
person is Happy we'll put a zero year a
one and a zero and if the person is sad
we'll put a zero year a zero and a one
and the way this encoding works is that
where we have a zero you see the
position is one for the one hot
representation where we have a one happy
person we put a one at the first
position what we have a sad person who
put a two uh we have a two and so we put
a one at the second position
and then with this there'll be some
differences in the designing of the loss
function which we are going to see in uh
subsequent sessions now we have this
binary for the binary is like the
previous example of the previous project
we worked in where we have uh two
classes so where we have two classes we
just have the level multiple binary in
our case we may pick out the integer or
the categorical
then from here we have the class names
now if you've decided to infer directly
from the class directory then it's
important to make sure that those class
names match the sub directories so
um you should ensure that if you're for
example you have this class names let's
let's put all the class names here so
you would have class names
and let's say we want to have
um Angry
we have Angry we have happy we have said
we have set okay so here's our class
names now uh if we don't put this
exactly as it is here we should have an
error so let's run this we have class
names there we get back here and instead
of having this here we're going to
specify our class names
so here we have our class names there we
go so we have that the next is the color
mode RGB the batch size by default is 32
the image size here the default is 256
by 256 we could always modify this
shuffling by default it's true so by
default we're going to shuffle our data
set so we do not need to explicitly do
this shuffling so we just have to
specify this to be true and that that's
done now for reproducibility we could
give a seed such that we always have the
same uh shuffling
then we have this validation split so
you're in a case where let's say we have
just one directory let's say we just
have the data set directory we do not
have this test we may want to split this
directory into the training and
validation so here we could have your
let's say 0.2 and automatically we're
going to have a split of this uh data
set into the training and validation
data sets now once you have the split
since you're creating the trend data set
you specify that this is training so
straining is actually in the
documentation here you have your
validation speed so an optional float
between the round one which is logical
since it was played in uh our data set
and then we'll specify either training
or validation so let's get back here so
in this case it will be training the
interpolation by linear follow links
false crop to aspect ratio false so
these are the default values we're not
going to use this take this half and in
this case in the case where we would
have had validation we just have your
validation so anyway we're not going to
use this let's take this off that said
by default the validation split is uh
known so optional offload there's no
we're not going to do any validation so
that said let's have this off and let's
run this and see what our data set our
train data set is about so here we have
6799 files belonging to three classes
now let's go ahead and modify this let's
add that is that let's run this now
and see what we get
you see already we have this error
because there's no match and the class
names passed in a match the names of the
sub directories of the target directory
so I expected this but insta received
this so let's get back modify it here
there we go
that's fine
we run this here
and that's fine okay so that's our
training data we could do the same for
our validation editor so validation or
let's say vowel and your string okay so
your stringers wow and we have the vowel
directory
we have the vowel directory let's ensure
that you're call this vowel vowel
directory
we get back and that's it okay here's
infer level mode int class name same
class names RGB 32 image size 256. now
let's
change this and have configuration
and batch size
okay so that's our batch size
here we have this as image size so in
size
take this off place that out we have
here in size okay so we have this
configurations and then we could create
this here
configuration
there we go
we have the batch size
which will take a value of 32 we have
the IM size we should take a value of
256.
so we have that let's run this
we get back here
um just configurations let's copy this
here
and that's fine we have our 2278 files
belonging into three different classes
for our validation data set
from here we're gonna do we're gonna
look at our data set so let's say for
um D or for image and level in Val let's
just say for for I in vowel data sets
let's take one let's take one batch
we're gonna print out I so around that
scroll down see we have the images we're
interested in looking at the levels for
now so let's go down let's scroll
uh up to this here okay you see the
levels we have two two zero zero one
it's a leveling is between zero and one
because we have three different classes
now let's modify this
instead of having the level more to ins
let's now this is INS already oh let's
change it to categorical category call
and this here
categorical run that run this
and okay so we'll see what we get so
here instead of having two you're
instead of having two two what we have
is this one heart representation
here where the everywhere zero except at
the second position so here instead of
having a zero we have everywhere zero
except at the zeroed position
so that's it now we shall go on to
visualize this there so here we have
this figure
and then we specify the figure size so
we have your fixed size
and we have this so it's a 12 by 12.
okay so we have that and then for images
and levels in our Trend data set we have
this in a train data set you could
always uh change this and put for
example the validation data set so we
have that now Trend it is set we'll take
just one then we create a subplot here
plt.subplot oh it's gonna be four by
four then I plus one okay so we have
that and then we'll do an IM show so we
show we plot out the image
uh basically this image uh right here
and then we select a given image so we
have that and then we
divide all these pixels values by 255 so
we have that and then next one next step
is to plot out the title so now we plug
another images then we then go ahead and
plot out the different titles
then here we have the outputs that's the
levels basically select the level so we
select a particular level just as we
selected the image and then we have
let's because because the levels will be
a one representation then we have to
take the ACT Max now if you're new to
this you could check out the previous
sessions where we talk about this kind
of methods here so we have the arc Max
of this and we have an axis let's
specify this axis zero that's fine
um I think here we should also just do
the platin so we should take off the
axis sorry so axis and off so let's run
this so you see what we get before we
have that anyway here we have numpy so
let's converted to numpy run that again
you have this output there we go you see
that we have the image and it's class
above now to convert this into some
words let's make use of the class names
so we have class names
class names and then yeah we have this
we run this again we now get the
different images and your levels at this
point our data set is now ready for
training we just have to include this
prefetching year for a more efficient
usage of our auditor we saw this kind of
prefetching how we explained what
Perfection was all about in some
previous sessions so here we have the
Perfection we're not going to include
the batching because you're already
we've included a batch size previously
so in this theater set loading right
here we specify the batch size so our
data is already bashed now we have that
we run the solve for the training and
then we simply redo this for the
validation so this is our validation
data validation
and now we're ready for building our
model but before going on to build our
model we shall copy out this code here
from the previous session and paste it
out here so we have this resize free
skill layers which we are going to
include in the model now recall that we
could do this resizing like we have our
data set here so supposing you have your
data set you could do the resizing and
rescaling your this risk killing and
there's a resize into the uh required
size before passengers data into the
model
so this could be done before passing to
the model such that you could uh train
your model
on this resized and rescaled data now
another method will be to pass in your
data
here so let's suppose that we have let's
take this off
we suppose that here we have
in this middle we have the resizing and
rescaling unit so we resize and reskill
before passing to the model now instead
of doing this what we could do is we
could pass the data into the model
directly and then carry out the resizing
and reskilling
in the model as a layer in the model now
we've seen this already but I will just
explain here again that doing this is
great for deployment because when you
have to deploy this kind of system you
no longer want to resize it again so
here all you do now is just pass in this
image and then the model on its owners
the model which has been deployed takes
care of resizing and reskaling unlike in
this kind of system where when you
deploy this model you have to do the
resizing and rescaling on your own so
this means that if you deploy this model
on some Cloud solution and then you're
calling it uh from a JavaScript client
for example or say some Android client
then you would have to carry out this
resizing and rescaling in JavaScript
unlike here where you just pass in the
image and the model takes charge of
resizing and reskaling so that said
let's take this off get back to our code
um yeah we're gonna have we're gonna run
this simply and then we start with
building our model here we have this
error resize not defined so simply we
have Keras layers here so we should
just as we did here to the resizing so
we have resizing there we go run that
cell again and then get back to
um
at this point our data set is now ready
for training we just have to include
this prefetching year for a more
efficient usage of our data we saw this
kind of prefetching how we explained
what Perfection was all about in some
previous sessions so here we have the
Perfection we're not going to include
the batching because you're already
we've included a batch size previously
so in this theater set loading right
here we specify the batch size so our
data is already bashed now we have that
we run the solve for the training and
then we simply redo this for the
validation so this is our validation
data validation
and now we're ready for building our
model but before going on to build our
model we shall copy out this code here
from the previous session and paste it
out here so we have this resize free
skill layers which we are going to
include in the model now recall that we
could do this resizing like we have our
data set here so supposing you have your
data set you could do the resizing and
rescaling your this killing and there's
a resizing to the required size before
passing this data into the model
so this could be done before passing to
the model such that you could uh train
your model
on this resized and rescaled data now
another method will be to pass in your
data
here so let's suppose that we have let's
take this off
we suppose that here we have
in this middle we have the resizing and
rescaling unit so we resize and rescale
before passing to the model now instead
of doing this what we could do is we
could pass the data into the model
directly and then carry out the resizing
and reskilling
in the model as a layer in the model now
we've seen this already but I will just
explained here again that doing this is
great for deployment because when you
have to deploy this kind of system you
no longer want to resize it again so
here all you do now is just pass in this
image and then the model on its owners
the model which has been deployed takes
care of resizing and reskaling unlike in
this kind of system where when you
deploy this model you have to do the
resizing and rescaling on your own so
this means that if you deploy this model
on some Cloud solution and then you're
calling it from
a JavaScript client for example or say
some Android client then you would have
to carry out those resizing and
rescaling in JavaScript unlike here
where you just pass in the image and the
model takes charge of uh resizing and
reskaling
so that said let's take this off get
back to our code
um yeah we're gonna have we're gonna run
this simply and then we start with
building our model here we have this
error resize not defined so simply we
have Keras layers here so we should
just as we did here to the resizing so
we have resizing there we go run that
cell again and we're now ready for
modeling
hi guys welcome to this session on
modeling in which we are going to build
our own model which permits US pass in
this kinds of inputs and it tells us
whether the input is that of a person
who is sad angry or happy in the session
we are going to start with the Lynette
model which we saw in the previous
session while modifying some parameters
to suit the problem we're trying to
solve and then move on to even more
complex and better computer vision
models we copy the code from the
previous session and paste out here so
um there is it we have this Lunette
model which we saw in the previous
example and then we also have this
finalize this number of classes here
which we have to set
so that set here we change this number
of classes from one to three now the
reason why we're doing this is simply
because in the previous session we're
building a net model which takes in
images and outputs whether this images
are those of a parasitic are a known
parasitic cell now in this example we've
taken in images and our model has to
decide whether is that of an angry
person a sad person or a happy person so
we see that here we have three different
classes and because of that we're gonna
change this to from one to three so we
have this we run the cell that's fine we
also have this other configurations the
learning rate number of ebooks the
dropout rate the regularization rate
number of filters Canal size number of
strides both sides number of layers
all rather outputs in this dense layer
and number of outputs in this other
dense layer
so with that we're just gonna run the
cell now note that you could always get
back to the previous sessions to
understand each and every parameter we
have here as we've discussed this
already so we just need to replicating
this Lunette model we've seen previously
now that said you see the kind of output
we got here we have six million
parameters we have our different layers
going from account layers to a fully
connected layers now
uh the next Point here is this
activation right here so this activation
now or with the previous case study was
the sigmoid and this was because we were
actually deciding whether an output will
be one class or the other it was a
binary classification problem wherein we
could use this kind of sigmoid
activation function with a sigma
activation function if you can recall we
have this input and we have this output
so let's say x gets in and Y goes out
and here's at zero the 0.5 here we have
this and one so what goes on here is as
we take in higher values of X the
sigmoid function approaches one while as
we're taking a high negative values of X
the sigma function I approaches zero and
so the range of values here is simply
zero to one and this is logical since in
the binary classification kind of
setting we're wanting to Output a zero
for one class or a one for another class
now intermediate value is like 0.7
will be taken to be either one of this
classes depending on our threshold but
then the role of the sigma here is to
make sure that all our values that's
based on all the inputs we are able to
have an output which always lies between
0 and 1 as we could see here you see
that we always in this range here 0 to
1. now in a case where we're having a
multi-class problem like in the case
where we have three different classes
like this and that what we don't want is
to just say for example here we have an
output 0.1
output
0.67 output say one so we do not want
this kind of
outputs right here since we're dealing
with a multi-class uh problem with
single level
since here our output cannot be
um two of those classes so in some
problems
or some kind of problems we may have a
situation where the person is maybe sad
and uh say angry at the same time now in
those kinds of situations you could
afford to have
these kinds of outputs where I say this
two-year these two classes have high
values nonetheless in the kind of
problem we're trying to solve we want
the model to choose or pick only one out
of the three different classes so we are
not going to pick two uh one we're going
to pick only one and because we're going
to pick only one what we'll have here uh
what we'll try to do here is to make
sure that this our output sums up to one
so instead of having uh let's take this
off instead of having this kind of
output we'll have an output which sums
up to one such that
this year if you have that such that one
the one with the highest class or the
one with the highest value is considered
as that class
which the model has selected
and so we could have all different kinds
of values we could have say 0.1 your
0.2 but here since we already have
0.10.2 we're going to have 0.7
since we want to ensure that the sum of
all those values should give us one you
look at this 0.3 plus 0.7 gives one so
we make sure that
our values here lie between 0 and 1 and
when we sum them up it gives us one
now an activation function which we
could use in achieving this is the soft
Max function so let's have here soft Max
so instead of the sigmoid now we have
the soft Max and to better understand
how the soft Max work so you clearly see
that difference let's take this example
from the analytics video.com website
in this example you're considering that
we have three or classes in this output
let's take this off here instead of 10
like what we have now here they have
just this three classes right here now
after applying the softmax we're gonna
have
um outputs here just like when you have
uh some output after applying the
sigmoid you have this other output so
just like for example if you have an
output let's say five after applying the
sigma or five you have a value of like
0.99 whatever so it's a very very close
to one whereas if you pass in a value
say negative 10 after passing in the
sigma you're going to have a value very
close to zero say 0.001 so this is how
the sigmoid works now for the
softmax function is quite different here
what goes on is we're gonna make use of
this formula here so we have e x let's
say x i or let's say XC for a particular
class divided by the sum of e x c for
all the classes now this formula
shouldn't scare you as we're going to
explain how it works in detail here that
said we have in this input just like
with the sigma where you have the the
input coming from the output of the
dense layer now here we have this here
we have obviously three inputs because
we have three different classes so we
have this one this one and this one now
you should note their values here let's
take this off so you can see the value
here so you know their values this one
is
um 2.33 negative 1.46
0.56 now once we have this we're going
to Simply apply this formula and the
ways I apply this as such you take this
value 2.33 you have the exponential of
that value so you have e to the power of
2.33 as you see here of that particular
class divided by the sum of all these
exponentials for all the different
classes so here you have e to the power
of 2.33 there is it divided by e to the
power of 2.33 Plus
here e to the power of negative 4 1.46
plus e to the power of 0.56 so you have
all this summed up that's basically what
this formula here means for all the
different classes sum up e to the power
of the values that these classes take up
now once you have that for this first
class class one you obtain this value
now for the next class you have e to the
power of negative 1.46 divided by this
same sum here so basically this sum is
uh the same everywhere but the only
difference is the numerator so you have
this numerator which changes here we
have 0.56 we have this other numerator
and we have this value notice how as the
value goes to us
um negative or high negative values
these values approaching zero while when
the values go into a high positive value
is approaching one so this means that if
we replace this and put a value like say
10 would have a value even very close to
one like say 0.9 so that's it and that's
basically how the softmax works so this
means that
at every given point when you sum up all
these outputs you have a total value
equal one so you could take the 0.83
plus 0.01 let's say 0.84 let's work in
two decimal places so 0.84 0.84 plus
0.14 is like 0.98 so you add this other
uh pass up to give you one so basically
what you're doing with the soft Max is
you're taking some inputs for let's say
three classes
and then you sharing the values so you
have one that you want to share you have
this number one which if you want to
share you're gonna give this one a
fraction of this whole one in this case
the fraction is 0.83 and then you're
gonna give this other one's own fraction
this other one it's on fraction such
that at the end all this year sum up to
be equal one from here we're gonna get
straight into the training and start by
designing our loss function so we have
this loss function which is going to be
the categorical cross entropy function
so unlike before where we had the binary
now we have this categorical cross
entropy we have it right here on the
documentation you have TF Keras losses
categorical cross entropy and then one
of those arguments is this from logits
now the from logits as giving your oh
let's get back here they're from lodges
by default is false so by default we
suppose that uh we have from largest to
be false and as given year this from
legit says whether the Y prep the Y
pressure is what the the other Y which
is outputted by the model so this is
whether the Y print is expected to be a
logic's tensor
or not and by default we assume that why
pred ankles are probability distribution
so by default
we are supposing that what the model is
gonna output in our case we have three
classes what the model is going to
Output is going to be such that when we
sum all these probabilities along with
some other outputs here it's going to
give us a value of one
and so when we have
this by default that's from logits to be
false so by default we have from largest
to be false when we have this is simply
meaning that we're supposing that what
is going to get into this last function
is going to be a logic tensor and that's
our case here because we've had or we
have this soft Max activation now in
case we didn't have to solve my
activation then we will have needed to
specify this or set this to True such
that what gets into the categorical
across entropy is a largest tensor
now that said let's go ahead and test
this example here we have this example
let's take this example copy this and
then just paste it out here
so we have this example there we go here
we have CCE category cross entropy we're
going to print this results so we print
out those results and see what it gives
us we run that and see we have a value
of 1.17 now this value here tells us
how close the model's Edition is to the
True Values of Y now let's modify our
model's predictions such that it's very
close to the True Values of Y so here we
have zero much of 0.05 okay 0.95 okay
zero zero zero zero point one zero zero
point eight now we should reduce this to
0.08 so it's very close to zero now your
answer of 0.1 let's say we have zero
point now let's let's change this to
0.05 and then here we have
0.85 okay so all this sums to one
um this two sums to one that's it you
see they are very close now now with
this we run the cell again and what do
you notice you see the value drops by
almost a factor of 10. so this shows us
that these two are very close to each
other now let's change this and say 0.0
let's have here 1.0
and your zero yeah zero so yeah 1.0 we
run that and what do we get you see you
have a value which is practically zero
and this is because these two values are
very close now if you change this again
so let's have your zero and have this
1.0 let's now make these values
completely different from each other so
here we have 1.0 and that so this means
that this year the actual prediction is
this uh position here well this one or
whatever this is a different position
now here the actual is this but the
model predicts this so the model uh
fails to predict for each case here so
here let's run this again and see how
high this value is so this shows us uh
how this categorical across entropy loss
actually works
now to gain even more in-depth
understanding of how this works let's
consider this following formula so if
this the categorical across entropy loss
defined here is simply uh we have this
negative year the sum of Y true log y
pred now we take this example here for
this case
or let's modify this
such that this first prediction year
matches this prediction and or rather
this uh second prediction matches this
second prediction and this year doesn't
match so this example let's yeah this
doesn't match so the first example
doesn't match while this other example
matches so what the model predicts
matches with what the model was meant to
predict now that said let's get into
this formula and see how it works so we
understand uh why we're getting high
values when there is no matching and
very low values when there is a match so
here for example we have zero this y
true just use a formula zero then log
of 0.01
now we have the summation so plus this
next example one this is why true one
log of 0.05
you have that plus next one zero log
of
0.96 now obviously this cancels because
we have zero here two we have zero this
goes away uh this goes away we left only
with this let's take this off
so we left only with this year after
this computation
okay now log of 0.05
gives us negative 1.3 approximately
negative 1.3 so we have uh year
approximately negative 1.3 but with this
negative year gives us 1.3 so we have
this value of 1.3 now let's explore
example here for this is a case where
there is a matching we have zero uh log
of 0.1 because we have 0 is not going to
be considered here we have zero again
zero here is going to multiply that it's
going to be zero now this other one we
have one so this is the one we have one
log of 0.7 One log of 0.7 what do we
have here
this gives us negative 0.15 so we have
approximately
0.15 so we see that with weather is a
matching the loss is reduced and when
there is no matching the loss value is
increased so with that we just simply
take this off since it's our default and
that's fine so we have this now but
before continuing let's also consider a
case where our outputs like let's get
back here we're going to run this again
get the loss we have so now we're going
to consider that this y true that's our
data set is going to be designed such
that instead of having this categorical
kind of output we're going to have the
integers so here instead of 0 1 0 we're
going to Simply have one now let's get
back to why this is uh so we have 0 1 0
this is translated that's this for
categorical on for integer this is
translated as one because the one is at
the first position so starting from zero
one two now in the case where we have
zero zero one this is translated as two
since these are the second position zero
oh zero one two so that's it so we had
seen this already in the previous
session now uh getting back here let's
modify this instead of having this let's
put one
and instead of having this let's put two
so we're seeing that if your data set is
designed in this way recall we have seen
it here
um just here let's get into data set
loading just here if the label mode is
int then you should have this kind of
design there you go right here okay so
we have this kind of design instead so
we just have these integers so if you
have this let's run this here you see it
doesn't work now what we'll do in the
case where we have this kind of
um output is we're going to use a sparse
category called so instead of the
categorical we have the supports
categorical you see you run that and you
have the exact same answer you will have
in the case where it was categorical
let's get back here
run that again so you have exact same
answer so that said we could make use of
the support categorical it depends on
how we uh created our data set so here
we have sparse categorical and we shall
just comment this since we're not making
use of that stick this off now and then
we move on to our metrics so here we
have the metrics uh The Matrix we'll be
using here will be the category call
accuracy so we have category called
accuracy
oh let's give it a name let's call that
uh accuracy and then we will also have
the top key accuracy there we go we have
our top key category called accuracy
we'll give it a name uh no before giving
it a name you need to give it the value
of K so we'll call we'll give a value of
K of 2 and then we give it a name
uh top
key accuracy now before we move on let's
explain this top key categorical
accuracy metric right here so unlike
with this accuracy with this categorical
accuracy
where if we have for example this four
situations here those four examples
um this those in blue are what the model
predicts and those in red are what the
model was expected to predict uh
accuracy will be computed as such
so it would have we'll start with this
first one
um the highest year is this 0.5 the
highest here is this since there is no
match we have a zero Plus
we move to this next one the highest
here is this the highest is the the
highest here is this and the highest is
this at this position there is no
matching so we have a zero and that's
because the class 0 was picked whereas
the expected what should have been class
one
now we get here the class 0 is predicted
by the model and the class 0 is also
what the model what was expected or what
the actual outputs so here we have plus
a one because we've gotten this
correctly so this is correct this is
wrong this is wrong now we get here we
have the same situation the highest year
is 0.7 the highest year is this and the
positioning is such that there's a match
so we have plus one now because we have
four different examples we divide all
this by four and multiply by a hundred
so this gives us accuracy of 50 percent
now
we get back uh to this case here for the
top kick categorical accuracy
for this first case the highest class
here is this one
the second highest class
is this other one year so we have this
highest class second and we have this
third so it's in this order
for this one year this is our first uh
we have two of them and then this one
this is our first and uh this this is
0.05 so yeah we have two of them this
here this uh first and this our second
so because we've selected k equal to
we're interested in just our first two
highest predictions so uh with the top K
category called accuracy we are not
interested in making sure that the
highest prediction here matches the
highest prediction year what we're
interested in here is if any of the two
highest matches the highest prediction
we expect so if any of the two
predictions of the model matches the
exact prediction the model should have
predicted then we'll give that or we
consider that as a correct prediction so
in this case here this first two do not
match this so this is around prediction
and we have a zero plus we move to this
next one year or the highest year is
this and it matches with the second so
we have a one so this is considered now
correct prediction unlike previously
where would I have considered this to be
a wrong prediction now for this one the
first two all those three uh there so
obviously this will be a random
prediction it also matches here the
first matches with this first year so we
have that plus one
and then this Auto one year we have the
highest prediction you're matching with
this so we have plus one so here we have
three divided by four times a hundred
this means that the top two category
called accuracy in this case is equal 75
percent unlike the categorical accuracy
which is fifty percent now with that we
go ahead and compile the model the net
model that compile let's run this we
have Adam learning rate we should
specify in the configuration the loss
function here the Matrix this and that's
it so we compile our model and then
we'll set now to train there we go let's
paste this out and here instead of this
here we should have configuration uh
number of ebooks then obviously we have
our training data set and we have our
validation data set so let's run this
and see what we get scroll down and
that's it see our loss is dropping
accuracy increasing and top key accuracy
which is clearly higher than the
accuracy actually now complete let's
plot out the loss curves for the
validation and the training as you could
see here both the violation and training
losses all dropped together while the
accuracies for the validation and
training also increase up to this point
here so it's almost getting to value of
one now you could check this out here
you see the accuracy
97.8 percent
um you're 98.19 so the model is
performing quite well we could evaluate
this model on our validation data and
here we have the Lunette model
dot evaluate
so we call the evaluate method and then
we pass in the validation data set
validation data set okay so we run this
and there we go we have a loss of 0.35
0.035 accuracy 98.33 top key or rather a
better steel top two accuracy
99.88 now note that given that the model
isn't overfitting the model keeps um all
the models metrics keep increasing what
you could do here is increase the number
of ebooks so you could train for more
ebooks to get even better results now
we're ready to test out this model on
some image in our test and data set so
yeah we're gonna have this image or
let's call it test image we have test
image which is going to be red or which
is going to be this image we're going to
read using opencv Library so we have
your cv2.m read and then just in your
let's open this up and the test uh let's
take up say happy we take or we copy
this path here let's copy this path
paste it here there we go and then we're
going to convert this into a tensor
let's close this we have here now our
test image oh let's say in is equal TF
dot constant test image and then we're
going to specify the data type so here
is uh float32
and then with that we're just going to
pass this so let's let's print out the
output uh let's first of all print out
the shape see see the image shape 90 by
90 by three then we're gonna pass this
into our model directly because as we
have designed this we have put in the
resizing in the model and the rescaling
tool so we're going to resize and then
we're gonna rescale in the model such
that now we do not need to do that out
of of the model so that's set let's get
back here and all we need to do is call
our internet model but before calling
that we need to do at one dimension
since uh we're passing this input in the
model as batches so we add the batch
Dimension here TF dot expand
dimensions and then we have the image we
specify the axis zero okay so once we
have this now let's have our learn net
model
which takes in that image so here we're
gonna print out this output
open out what our model gives us we get
in this error here where we told that
there is incompatibility issues between
the input image
and what the model expects
that said we get back to the model and
we noticed that we didn't actually put
the resizing so let's get back here and
we have this recital skill layers which
we have built already and we put that
instead of this rescaling we have this
resize free skill so we make sure we
resize and we reskill okay now uh next
thing we have to do is we have to modify
this here because here by doing this
we're supposing that the input is going
to be 256 by 256 but yeah what we'll
have is that we'll have this noon so our
input could be any of any Dimension but
we are going to do the resizing here so
we have the resizing in this uh recital
skill layer and then we also have the
reskilling so that's it let's run this
there we go as you could see you have
from here we have this uh 256 by 256 by
3 and that's because we've actually
passed this input into our resizer scale
layers so let's go ahead and retrain our
model
your training and validation plots for
the loss and accuracy and with this we
could go ahead and test our image so
let's run that and this is what we get
as you could see here we have
practically zero uh 0.99 and then almost
zero so this shows us clearly that our
class the class 1 in this case because
here this is a class zero
I'll take that off
this is our class 0 plus 1 and class two
so uh this image is of class one and
it's correct because this is a happy
image so basically you see how to
um create this
image here this image array from the
file path and then convert this into a
tensor which is then passed into the
model without any pre-processing
another thing we want to do is to
actually print out the class so what we
can do here is instead of this Lunette
model we'll have tf.org Max so we'll
look for the class or with the highest
probability which in this case is this
one we'll look for that class so tier
The Arc Max we specify the axis now if
you're new to this you could check our
previous sessions where we treat uh
these kinds of functions uh thoroughly
so here we have that let's run this you
see we have zero zero no this is T of
the AG Max this is negative one or one
let's say negative one is the last axis
okay we have that you see it picks out
this here and then from here let's
convert this to numpy
and then from here we use the class
names to get its name so there we go
class names we run that
um we're given this
let's see what we obtained before this
class names let's take this off
and also take this one off we run that
okay we have this list so should take
the zeroth element
there we go now we have that we put in
the class names
and we get the name
so that's it see we get the name happy
okay so with that now let's do one last
test let's take sat for example and we
see how easy it is to carry out such
tests let's pick out an image here
let's take this one you could actually
view this image here so that's it uh
this one has the same image take out
this other one you see we have this okay
so let's copy this path
take this off take this off
scroll up and then simply paste it here
so this is the path we're trying to know
exactly from the model what kind of
image it is so you see here it's a sad
image and this is uh from the test set
so make sure you doing this kind of
testing we did the model has never ever
seen okay so that's it our model is
performing quite well
we can do something similar to what we
had here but with the difference that
instead of just giving out these levels
will give out not only these levels but
also what the model predicts so let's
copy this code here get back to our
testing there we go and paste it out
here okay so again we're not going to
use the train but the validation data
set so there we go we have our
validation this is set we have the spots
and then at the level of the title we
plot
um let's have this true
level right here and then we will have
the predicted level so let's have this
move to the next line and then we have
uh predicted
level
uh yeah which is the level there we go
and that's fine so we have this
predicted level
and we'll get it from here so we could
simply have the net model
um learn that model here we have a
Lunette model which takes in the images
so it takes in the image selects a
particular image and let's do the let's
expand them so we have
expand dimension
taking that image
of axis equals zero and we close that
okay so we have this we pass in the
linen model and we have this output now
uh we are going to do something similar
again to what we had here uh basically
it's even this year so let's just copy
this
let's just copy this and replace it
right here so it's the same thing we're
trying to do all we're trying to do here
is actually
uh passing the image into the model and
get its class so we compare with the
actual level so here we have this class
names and this we have Plus
this should be fine and that's it
with this now let's run this cell and
see what we get scroll
here's what we get you see the model
this is supposed to be true the model
here doesn't perform quite well unlike
what we had in this evaluation so let's
check out our code and see if there's
any errors
um scroll this way uh here you see we
have in this will be images so we have
that that's why you see the presenter is
always sad so we have always a predicted
level always sad because we had taken or
we had picked just one image and it's
not Dynamic so here we have this images
we select a particular image and we run
this again
they should be fine
we get in this error because we didn't
add the batch Dimension unlike here we
added a batch Dimension before passing
in here so let's get back and then we're
going to replace that images
uh the image with this code here so
let's get back here and then replace
this with this code note that we've
traded this already in previous sessions
so you could always check out if you're
new to methods like expand dims okay we
run that
and see what we get okay so that's it
this is what we get you see happy happy
angry happy true level happy presented
happy
um let's see if there's any errors the
model does quite well see no errors so
it's almost 100 in fact it's a hundred
percent although the evaluation year
shows 98
98.33 the next thing we'll do is plot
out the confision metrics
so we're gonna go through our validation
data for aim level in our validation
data set
we are going to
store the levels in this list right here
so we have levels that are pen the level
and then we also have predicted dot
append
the Lunette model which takes in the
images so here we have what the model
predicts and what the model should
predict
so here we have predicted
create this list and then levels we also
have this list there we go so we have
now this
um that's it so with this now let's run
the cell
and then before moving on we'll convert
this to numpy format so we could easily
manipulate it so we have this as numpy
we run this again
that's fine
then here we could print out the levels
we have levels let's print this out
there we go you see the levels the
different levels now let's try to
flatten out all those different levels
right here so let's have this to be
flattened now let's scroll up see this
uh they're in batches of 32 so
we can actually see that here let's
scroll down a bit you see we have this
batch here then we have the next batch
and so on and so forth but then this
output format isn't exactly what we want
what we want is the classes as a class
with the highest score so instead of
this one representation we we want the
integer representation so what we're
going to do here is use the AG Max so
let's pin out the AG Max of this
oops uh let's get back up let's print
out the ARG Max of this
there we go and then we specify the last
axis so we have that and we run that
are we getting an error or we have this
error now let's let's do this let's pick
out or let's simply select your up to
the last value now this error should be
coming in because we have batches of 32
but it happens that if you have a data
let's suppose that you have a data set
of 48 items now if you break this in
batches of 32 then you have uh let's
let's even say 98 okay so here you have
the first batch 32 the next batch 32 the
next batch 32 so yeah you already have
96 elements and then the last batch will
be two because you have you want to have
98 elements here you have 96 plus 2
given 98 so because of this last batch
here we get we get in this error here so
because of that we get the error so what
we could do is print right up to this
last batch so let's let's uh run that so
we're not going to pick out the last
batch here we're not picking out the
last batch so we go from uh the first
batch to right up to the uh batch before
the last one so let's run this now and
you see that that's fine so this works
out well we could even print out say the
first two batches let's print out the
first two batches so you see what that
looks like you see this is the first two
batches you have this here and this now
from here you could actually flatten so
you could do this you flatten this so
you get all this in this single or one
dimension list so that's why we want to
get now let's move on so let's get back
to this we have right up to the last
batch
um we run this
and there we go so this is what we get
so we've actually flattened out all
these elements now if you print out the
length of this here
see you print out this length you see
you have
6784 elements so now basically we want
to compare this different predictions
here I want to compare this predictions
let's take this length off I want to
compare this uh levels sorry you want to
compare all those levels with the models
predictions so here we could repeat the
same process with a predicted let's have
predicted
or predict that we run that you see we
have this two lists here it's already
that they're quite similar although this
one misses out so what we're doing is we
having this list and this other list
this for the predicted and this for the
levels so now that we have the set less
of defined or let's redefine our bread
let's say pred uh we'll call Pratt to be
this year so this is our pride which
will flatten out so these are the
different predictions by the model and
then this is what the model was supposed
to predict so the other levels so pretz
and levels okay so let's have that we
run that cell and then we get back to
the code for the coefficient Matrix
which we had previously so basically
here we are seeing the previous sessions
we Define this threshold because we're
having binary classification problem
here since we have different classes we
wouldn't Define that we will just simply
pass in as here this uh different
prediction so for the levels and for the
predicted
um we have that let's simply copy this
out and paste out here so we've seen
this already let's take this off
now we have level and then here we have
the predictions
there we go we're going to print out
this coefficient Matrix we have the
figure and that's it so let's run this
and see what we get there we go we see
already here we have this conversion
Matrix and one thing you can notice
straight away is that the most values
are the the leading diagonal
has those elements with the highest
value so it's here we have the highest
values here and this is normal actually
because when you have this confusion
Matrix like this let's redraw this
coefficient Matrix when you have this
confusion Matrix like this this is a
class zero so let's say class 0 is angry
so this is class angry
yeah happy and sad now you're angry
happy and sad so whenever the prediction
or whatever what the model predicts
matches with what it was supposed to
predict you have a an additional one
which is added here so we simply go
through all the different model
predictions for the validation and you
see that
1472 times
for 1472 times the model predicted angry
when it was actually angry so this is
correct now for happy you see 2000 here
in my his matches here
2890 times the model predicts happy and
the actual was happy and here we have in
2198 times the model predict sad when
it's actually sad
and then here we have 21 times the model
predicts angry when it was happy and
then 26 times the model predicts angry
when it was sad then we have 20 times
the mother produced happy when it was
angry here we have it's 27 times the
mother produced happy when it was sad
here we have 30 times the model predict
sad when he was angry and we have a
hundred times the model pretty sad when
it wasn't said happy so there is you see
there's this is the highest call we
obtained for
the wrong predictions and so this means
that the model has that tendency of
predicting sad when it's actually happy
you can also observe this plot here you
see uh this lighter colors you see here
as we go up we get to this higher values
see here and then this and this so the
lighter the color the higher the score
and the darker the color the lower the
score
now obviously the ideal case will be
where we have this purely white so we
would have this purely white this purely
white this purely white and all this
you're completely dark with all zero
values
so that's sad we've looked at how to
have the obtain the confusion Matrix
which is an important evaluation metric
and here we could also change this to
training so anyway
um you just have to have your training
and that will be fine now we have to
deal with that last
um the last batch we should not take
into consideration so what we could do
is we could do some concatenation here
so let's do concatenate concatenate
and then we have that then let's copy
this we just copy this and paste out
your copy and then paste it out your
there we go but then we're taking the
last element so instead of the all
elements before the last now we're
taking the last element and that's it so
we add then we're adding that last
element here so that we could actually
flatten it out separately before
concatenating it with the previous
elements we saw that uh having all of
this joined together will cause an error
so that's what we why we're doing this
here again we copied this here let's
copy this and then paste it out here
that should be fine uh this for the
predicted so let's change this to
predicted
predicted okay so we should have that
fine uh scroll this way
and then let's have concatenate
okay so let's run this and see what we
get uh we get in this error
let's add this here
there we go we run that again that's
fine and the same should be for the
predicted so let's run this again get
that error
scroll this way and add this here
okay so we have this uh the last batch
which has been added up and then it will
simply copy this and paste here so now
instead of having just uh the the all
the values before the last we have now
all the different batches together so
here's for the predict no just for the
level so yeah let's put this here we
have the levels and then this is for the
predicted let's copy this get right to
the end and we have that okay so here we
have this for the predicted space this
year and that should be fine let's run
this again
run that and then we run this
and there we go see we have slightly
different answers now okay so that's it
we've seen how to plot out the
coefficient Matrix for multi-class
classification before we move on we
notice that we've made a very uh big
mistake here as all those validation did
is set we actually pass in the train
data set so let's modify this and make
sure you never make this kind of error
as if you make this kind of error you
feel like your model is performing well
whereas we're validating on the train
data so let's rerun this again so I have
to run this again
now training is complete and we see that
the model wasn't performing as well as
we thought you see here the last drops
and then at some points that's
increasing while that of the training
keeps dropping and then for the
validation we have this accuracy going
towards one as we had previously whereas
for validation your it uh plateaus at
around 75 percent as you could see here
in this values so you see the validation
accuracy the highest we have there's
like 75 percent although the the top key
accuracy is about 90 okay so that said
we see that we see clearly there are
models in performing that well and the
next sessions we'll see how to better
this model performance
yeah we could also run this evaluation
we have the evaluation CR 75 90 and loss
of one
um let's run this testing
correctly classifies this
um next we're gonna try this out to see
previously we had uh generally 100
because that was on our
same Trend dealer now here you see let's
start from up you see wrong prediction
right wrong wrong
um you have here wrong right right right
wrong see you see that out of the 16
different predictions we have uh 10 out
of 16 right so we're running that you
see you have that is 62 percent on this
little sample which you took here now we
could also plot the conversion Matrix
let's run this
and you can see clearly from here that
the model isn't performing as well as it
used to perform when we're making that
error
hello everyone and welcome to this new
session in which we are going to treat
data augmentation
previously we had seen how to load our
data set from this data set directory
right here and then we trained a Lynette
model which performs very well on the
training data but didn't perform as well
on the validation did and then we're
able to evaluate this model on different
evaluation metrics like the accuracy top
K accuracy and the coefficient metrics
in this session we are going to focus on
data augmentation that is we're going to
see the effect of augmenting our data
artificially without actually getting to
add an element in this data set right
here and then seeing how this affects
our model performance
in this session we'll see how to
augment a data like those data right
here
and see how this technique of data
augmentation helps in making the model
even more performant now we have looked
at the documentation previously but if
there's one thing you have to note about
the documentation is simply the fact
that it promotes diversity in your data
set and so if you have data like this
one year let's open this
we consider this original theater so
this is our original data this is the
data we actually gather and then we have
this brightness here so we modify this
data all these images brightness and we
obtain this other uh data point and then
we modify from this we rotate this and
we obtain this other data point you see
that it's the exact same image which has
been modified and so now the model
doesn't only get used to seeing this
image right here but now you could see
this one uh this one
and so that augmentation is this method
or this technique for promoting
robustness in models hence fighting
overfitting as now the model can see
different versions of certain data
points so let's close this up and get
back to the code here let's get back up
here we have the documentation we're
gonna simply get back to this year we
have the documentation we looked at this
already in the previous session so you
could uh get back and try to understand
exactly how this is carried out
previously we have seen that we could
carry out the documentation by using
this kinds of tensorflow image methods
like this one you see you could rotate
the image you could flip left right you
could adjust the saturation or you could
use Keras layers here we're going to use
Keras layers and then also we saw how to
use augmentations Library which is this
amazing Library which permits Us carry
out the documentation on different types
not only classification very easily so
you could check out that video now that
said let's simply copy this out here
then we paste it here so we have this uh
we're gonna we have this augment layers
we have random rotation random flip
random contrast let's actually get back
here in this layers and then add the
random contrast so we have random
contrast okay so we have that and you
could feel free to get back to the
documentation on the tensorflow Keras
layers let's get to Keras layers and
then check out those different
augmentation strategies here you can see
random brightness contrast crop flip
height rotation translation random
weight random zoom and you could check
out your documentations in case you have
any doubts so you could just have this
here and you see how uh to use each and
every one of those augmentation
strategies now getting back to the code
we have this three year now what was
generally done is you could actually run
one and then this is or this how it
helps in making the bet the model
perform better and then you could add
the other and see whether it helps and
so on and so forth so it's kind of like
it's not a fixed um
kind of method where you just have some
fixed methods or some fixed augmentation
strategies which you just place in this
order sequentially and then it will
always work magically generally you'll
have to test this out different tests
different strategies out and then see
which one works well for the data you're
working with
now we have this set let's run this cell
right here we have this is not defined
um let's let's get back here let me show
that this we run this cell let's run the
cell
normally that should be fine get back
and we run this one here and that's fine
so we have that and then now at a level
of this data set preparation we're gonna
include that we're gonna do the mapping
so yeah we have our augment layers note
that we're not going to do this for the
validation data set we're going to only
do this for the training data set we
have this augment layers and then we're
going to specify the number of parallel
calls so we have non-parallel calls and
then this has got an VR auto tune so we
have that automatically
then before we move on we're going to
copy this out here
and then simply paste this here
so we create this augment layer which
takes this and then has that's it
outputs the augmented image and the
level you're not going to have this here
so let's just take this off we have just
this image okay so that's it uh we have
this augmented layers
and then we'll Define this function as
augmented layer so right here let's take
this one off and run this again
with this we're now set to train so
let's go ahead and retrain our model
train is now complete and we could see
that the model doesn't perform as well
as it used to do without augmentation so
you see here we did augmentation the
model performs even poorer as compared
to when there was no augmentation let's
run this year so you could see
I could compare this with the previous
results we got of the previous
evaluation you see we go from 75 percent
to 54 and then here we go from 90 to 83
percent
to understand the reason why we have
this drop in performance let's look at
this visualization of our data set we'll
see that after carrying out the rotation
we have images which are rotated at
very unusual angles so you see like this
image here is unusual of this angle tool
looks very unusual
as compared to the kind of data we would
have in our test or validation set so we
have to ensure that when carrying out
this random operation we limit the angle
at which we could carry out this
rotation so that said if we have a face
like this or let's say we have an input
image like this we should limit this
rotation such that this image cannot be
rotated at say 180 degrees so let's have
this here so you see that better we have
this this and this so we do not want
this kinds of rotations what we want is
rotations where we have the face a bit
tilted like this
and that's it so we want this kind of
rotations but not this type so to solve
this problem what we're going to do is
we're gonna get back to the
documentation that's random rotation we
check out this Factor right here we see
that the value we put here takes us from
negative 20 of 2 pi Piers 180 degrees
pies and radians convert this to degrees
we have uh Pi which is 180 degrees so we
have two times 180 which is 360. so when
you say 0.2 or negative 0.2 what you're
in fact saying is negative 20 of
360. so when you have let's get back to
the code so when you have your let's add
this cell here when you have your 0.25
what you're having is 0.25 times
360. running this you see you're going
90 degrees so this means that if you had
an image which was already somehow
tilted this image will end up in the
very unusual position where the face
will look something like this
and so what we'll do here is we are
going to limit this rotation so we're
gonna we're gonna go from 0.025 for
example to this so let's limit that and
negative we'll go from negative 0.025
meaning that uh we have here that's
0.025 that will be nine degrees so
limiting this to 90 degrees and then uh
going from negative 0.025 to 0.025
Simply means that if you have this axis
here and then you have the face like
this let's put them out in this then
after rotation you can only go
90 degrees in the direction
or 90 degrees in this already nine
degrees in this direction so you have a
limit so you can you can only pick a
random value between uh negative nine
degrees and 9 degrees in the direction
so you can only go this way 90 degrees
or this way 90 degrees so that said the
extreme will have a face like this
that's after rotation so we'll go from
this blue to this red or you could also
get something like this
so this is what we're gonna get after
rotation unlike with the case of 90
degrees where if you have a face which
is already let's let's change this let's
delete this if we have a face which is
already say tilted like this
you have a face tutor like this after
rotating 90 degrees what you will have
now let's let's have here at least 90
degrees
what you have now will be a face tilted
this way
and
this isn't a very usual position when
taking an image so or when taking a
photo so the image is now validation or
tests did set wouldn't look like this
and so that's why we actually limited
this year
so let's get back to our code now and we
run this let's run this uh training
theater and then let's visualize our
data set
there we go as you can see you do not
have images which are upside down as we
had before
and that's it so we have this now we now
go ahead and retrain our model and see
what we get
after training for over 20 ebooks your
results we get you see that we go up to
78 so those are the highest we get and
when we run the evaluation you see here
we have this
when we run the evaluation what we get
is
77.8 percent for the accuracy and the
top case 91 so improved compared to what
we had before
or what we had before the data
augmentation now we are going to use
another documentation strategy which is
the cut mix now the cut mix
isn't like this other documentation
strategies where we just uh modify a
single image with academics as we have
seen in the previous sections we
actually combine two images so what
we're gonna do here is we're gonna
simply copy out this code and then put
it out in this uh our code base right
here now if you haven't or if you're new
to the cut mix the documentation you
could check out the previous sessions
where we treat this in detail so let's
get here and there we go we're gonna
apply cut mix and see the effect it has
after training our model so we have the
documentation in here let's let's add
the cell and have your cut mix
augmentation
I could sell and let's paste out that
part of the code
we also paste out this part where we
have the trend data set one another
Trend data set two then we create this
mixed data set so from here we have
augment
augments layer let's take this off
and here we have augment
layer so we carry out augmentation for
this tool separately and then once we
have this two-year we're not we're not
going to shuffle we're going to
shuffling already so we just do the
mapping we do the mapping
and that's what we're saying once we
have this two-year you're going to
combine this into this one mixed data
set so that's it let's uh have that and
then from here now we build our training
data set so let's uh take this here
let's take this up
there we go did you say preparation and
then we're now gonna comment this part
so we could comment this one and we have
a validation that is set that's fine
everything looks fine and that's okay so
we have this set let's run this now for
our cut mix you could always try to mix
up all the cut out augmentation
strategies
and see how it better or how it
ameliorates your model performance so
let's have this let's run this
there we go this is our cut mix here
and we combine it to these sets and then
once the combined we now apply the cut
mix augmentation
here we have this IM size not defined
um
let's actually you should have okay this
should be our configuration so we should
have this configuration
We Run The Cell now
run that again run the cut mix
and we run the cells and now everything
should be fine so there we go we have
all this fine and then we get to
validation around that
training data set and validation data
sets Okay so that's it let's go ahead
and retrain our model and see what we
get
after training for training ebooks we
noticed that unlike previously where the
training was went to about 99
while the validation was about 77
percent year the trainings about 80
percent and the validation let's scroll
this way the validation is about or the
highest we have here is 78 percent
so this shows us clearly that the model
isn't over fitting because the training
and the validation did set
both are evolving in a similar manner so
let's scroll down here and look at this
curve is here before look at the
accuracy plot before what we had was
something like this
we had the training
and yeah we had one or and then the
validation was like this but now we have
these two curves which are evolving in
similar manner though sometimes we have
these kinds of Peaks anyway
um
clearly our model isn't overfitting so
what we'll do is we're going to train
for more ebooks so that said let's go
ahead and retrain this model for more
ebooks so yeah we're gonna modify the
number of epochs so here we just have to
or what we can do simply is we just keep
training so we train for 20 more ebooks
so let's run this and then wait for 20
more Epoch training now complete the
other results we get as you could see
the validation accuracy starts to
stagnate around this and then after
evaluation we obtain an accuracy of
79.71 but what's interesting to note
here is the fact that our training
accuracy
is still having this value of 86.25
unlike previously when where our model
was overfitting we had uh this accuracy
of about 99 so that's it we have that
we've evaluated we see those values and
then uh testing on this values here you
see that we have 14 out of 16 images
predicted correctly and here's our
conversion metrics right here see that
clearly this model performs best or comp
performs better than all the other
previous models
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
gonna treat tensorflow record tensorflow
records helps us build more efficient
data pipelines as they help us store
data which we are used to train our
models more efficiently and also the
help in parallelizing the reading of the
data hence helping and speeding up the
overall training process and so in this
section together with the tensorflow
data sets which we've seen already we
are going to see how to implement
an efficient training Pipeline with
tensorflow in the previous sections
we've been working with tensorflow data
sets in this session we'll see how to
convert our tensorflow data set into a
tensorflow record and then get this
tensorflow record and convert it back to
tensorflow data sets to be used for
training now the very first question you
ask yourself is given that we've already
carried out this training process
successfully without any problems why do
we need to work with tensorflow records
now there are two major problems
tensorflow records come to solve order
two advantages of working with
tensorflow records the very first one is
the fact that
you can now store your data more
efficiently now notice that every time
you have to create this data you're
creating this data from this data set
which we've loaded here which is made of
little files of like say a few kilobytes
let's open this up so you could see it
for yourself we have this here let's
take this one uh open this folder and
then we'll see the size of this so you
could see the size is about
17.26 kilobytes now the fact that we
have to do with deal with this kind of
files means that we are not going to
always have to load this ditter very
efficiently now it's true working with
the tensorflow data sets brings in some
efficiency but what if we start this
data in a very efficient manner that is
instead of storing let's say for example
17 kilobytes files like this what if we
just store say 10
megabyte files or say a hundred Mega
gigabyte files so every time we want to
read from a file we don't have to read
from many of these kinds of files but
from a single file like this one
then another good thing with having to
work with tensorflow records which start
in this kind of form is that this time
around you could
um
carry out the pre-processing before
starting the data so you could augment
your data so we have augmented ditter
which is now stored as tensorflow
records so instead of having the images
and then getting here and each and every
time you have to carry a documentation
or some pre-processing before training
you store the data which has been
augmented already so uh suppose you have
your initial data so you have your
initial data year
it passes through some pre-processing so
it passes through some pre-processing
and then let's change this color so here
we have the dealer and then here we have
the pre-processing and then from the
pre-processing we have the augmented
data so after this the data has been
augmented what we do is instead of
having to go through this each and every
time what we'll do is we pass through
we'll go through this once and we store
our data and this is augmented form such
that the next time we want to train our
model all we need to do is just make use
of this augmented data right here
apart from this it should be noted that
sometimes we have models or we have
sections of a model let's draw it this
way
uh we have let's suppose that this is
our model here so this is our model it's
made of section one and section two the
section one is fixed meaning that we are
not going to train this part but we're
going to train only this part this means
that when you pass in theater right here
when you take this data and you pass in
your the output you would have here is
going to be the same
each and every time given that this year
is fixed the the weights here are fixed
so what we could do is instead of
starting the theater we are going to
start this outputs which we could call
embeddings so instead of storing the
data we store this embeddance here such
that we now make use of the embeddings
directly and train our model or train
this part of the model which is actually
trainable on this embeddance instead of
working with a dealer so this time
around we see that we have data uh the
pre-processing the augmentation and then
we have the embedded or the embeddance
from this data so here we have the
embeddance so we can now store this as
tensorflow records so you see that it
gives you or gives us some kind of
flexibility as to what we can store
and be able to retrieve the start data
and make use of it as we wish
the second major advantage of working
with tensorflow records apart from this
um efficiency in storing data is the
fact that they encourage the
parallelizing of reading data now this
means that if we're having to train our
model on several hosts let's say we have
four different hosts or say we have four
different machines on which we're
training our data like this and we have
our data set right here
what we could do is we could create
shards of our tensorflow record data so
here for example this let's suppose that
these are our data set or complete data
set we could break this up into several
parts so let's say we break this up such
that each host takes care of two so we
have one two one two one two one let's
add another part here so each of this
takes care of this so this this host
here trains on this theater that's what
I want to install this that's what I
want trains on this this one trains on
this
now as a rule of thumb is generally
advisable to make sure that each host
has about 10
of these packs of 10 to 100 Mega
bytes of our data set
so that said if we have a 10 gigabyte
data set like suppose that all this now
is 10 gigabyte let's take this off
we have our 10 gigabyte data set let's
write this in here
so you have your 10 gigabyte data set
what we want to do is have here that is
each and every host taken care of at
least uh 10
packs of our tensorflow of our our
tensorflow record which we've created so
let's take this off it's no longer two
we have to create 10 packs or 10 charts
of our tensorflow records and allocate
that to each and every host we have here
now that said given that we have four
hosts then we will have four times ten
shards to create
so we'll break this 10 gigabyte did set
up into 40 different parts so we have 40
different part uh packs or charts of our
tensorflow data set
or rather for tensorflow record right
here and then each and every one of them
will be approximately
250 megabytes
since 10 gigabytes that if we convert
this to megabytes we would have 10 000
we suppose that uh a thousand megabytes
equal a gigabyte so we have your 10 000
megabytes divided by 40 which will give
us 250 megabytes per Shard or per pack
that we've created your uh split of our
tensorflow records
and so this will lead to some reasonable
gains because we now can
train our model on this parallelized
data and then we could also
prefetch huge chunks of our data set to
be precise 250 megabytes
such that once the model is ready the
model just fits on this data which has
already been prefetched now you could
check out the previous sessions where we
talk about prefetching under tensorflow
data sets
that said what we actually store in this
tensorflow records are this protocol
buffers and the way tensorflow manages
this is by making use of this tensorflow
example
class which is defined here let's check
this out your tensorflow example which
is defined here as a standard Proto
storing data for training and inference
and so if you have to convert your data
into this uh into the product files you
would have to make use of this
tensorflow example class and then you
have to understand this representation
right here and so in our case where
we're dealing with an image and its
corresponding level let's say we have
the image of this person smiling we have
the level one so we have this image and
the presence corresponding level would
have to convert this data into this
format before creating a tensorflow
records
now here we have this dictionary as I
said here it contains a key Value Store
example that features where each key
which is a string maps to a feature
now note that here we have this feature
with s and here without s
so we have this features and each and
every one of them is a feature so we
could click here you could click here
and you see this feature you check out
the documentation and we have the this
contained let's take this off the
content list can be one of the three
types a byte list generally this is uh
information uh float list or an ins 64
list so you would uh pick your feature
depending on the kind of data you're
having now here you have this features
which is like a combination of those
different features here so you have here
the int list uh you have the float
feature the flute list byte list and
then here you create the you create the
features
from this different features your so
from this from each and because this is
a feature this this this one year this
one year is a feature let's take this
off this one here is a feature this is a
feature and this is a feature this has
been defined already here so you can see
ins feature is of type feature there is
it float feature the same there is it
bytes feature the same that is it now
all this combined forms features which
is of type features see the difference
you have this and this without the S
August is a singular on this plural so
that said uh if we want to create our
tensorflow records I want to convert our
data sent tensorflow records we have to
take into consideration this formatting
of our data
so we get back to the code and then
we'll add these two Imports here here we
have this tensorflow train we import by
at least float list and N64 list so
these are the types of uh feature and
then we have from tensorflow training
again we import example we import
features and we import feature so with
that let's run the cell
we get back to our code we have your
tensorflow records now what we'll start
by doing is unbatching our data so we'll
start by unbatching our data Note that
uh to run this we've taken we've taken
off this prefetching as we will not need
this we'll just take our data as it is
so we have our Trend data set which has
been augmented you could carry out any
pre-processing you want before starting
this data and then the validation data
remains validation so we have that vowel
data set there then from here we've run
the cells already from here we'll go
ahead and unbatch this data
there we go we have training data set we
run this we have this here then we do
the same for the validation so here we
have
validation data set and validation is
set on batched there we go we have that
you could see for yourself training
indeed is set
training data set this is going to be
unmatched so you have to unbashed data
set notice that the batch Dimension is
taken off you could simply have this for
the validation there we go validation
you run that see that taken off two
and then we get back to this
documentation recall that before
creating the tensorflow records we need
to put our data in a second format more
specifically we need to create Proto
files and the way we do this is by
making use of tensorflow example
and then to create this tensorflow for
example we have this features which we
need to combine to create this
tensorflow examples and in this
documentation here we have all that is
needed to create this so here you see
for example this example here we could
copy this out Simply and then we paste
this right here so you could see the int
the float the bytes but since we are not
going to use the the floats here we
could take this off we're not going to
use this float feature while interesting
is the byte feature because recall we
have the image and we have the level so
we have uh the image of the person happy
and then we have the level one so this
level will be this ends feature and the
image will be the bytes feature so let's
go ahead and get this done we have here
uh let's put this first so here we have
our bytes
and then we have our int now we're going
to create an example from here you can
see clearly we've imported this already
so we just have that if in here you
could have this features there we go
here we have byte list see uh yeah we
have feature here we have feature
here we have in 64 list
feature of time is 64 list and that
should be it so we have all this here we
need we take this off we don't need that
so here we have we'll change this name
we put we'll call this image
we'll call this image or images and then
we'll call this levels so that's it okay
so we have this year let's get back
that's fine we have that uh the bytes
the images and we have the levels now
once we have this the next thing to do
is to put in the correct uh values in
here so instead of having this here we
take this off
and then here we're going to create a
method which we'll call create example
call this method create example is going
to take our image and also the level so
it takes in the image and the level and
then what it returns
is our serialized example so we've had
this example which I've created and
these are serialized examples so we pass
we call the serialized to string method
right here
now that's set instead of this here
we'll take in our image and then instead
of this year we'll take in our level so
that's that should be fine we now run
this and the next thing we'll do is
Define the number of charts here we have
10 charts and then the path so you'll
call the stencil flow records let's
create this new folder here TF records
that's okay TF records that's fine and
then we will have the shards with your
uh specific uh number so here we have
the chart or basically we have this name
let's have here file name
and then here's the extension.tf record
okay so that's it and then we can run
this and then the next thing we want to
do
is to get back to the documentation
tf.io and then we get to this TF record
writer where we are going to see how to
write in a TF record file so we have
this year
um
um here's a simple definition
arguments you specify the path and you
also use this example so we have here
rise direct us to a file so let's copy
this simply
and then we paste this year so we have
with this
um TF record writer we specify the path
your our path is going to be uh this
path we have that path and then as file
writer we're gonna write our information
in that now
we want our file to get those different
names so here we have path.format
and then we'll specify a given chart so
or a given part of our leader so let's
uh get back here recall that when we
create our tensorflow record we could
create this as a block like this and
then we'll later on chart this break it
up into different parts so here exactly
we have 10 charts so break this up into
this 10 different parts one two three
four five six seven eight
uh nine ten okay so there we go we have
this 10 different charts and then we
want each chart to have a different file
name and that's why if you look at this
here you see we have this formatting
such that we
pass in a given chart number in here so
we have the sharp number
so that's it and what we'll do now is
for each Shard that's out of this 10
shots here for uh short number
in
range
number of shards that's more shots you
specify here on workshops 10 so it's
basically for short number in 10 so we
are going to go through we're going to
Loop through this and we're gonna create
a file for each chart so breaking up
here so for each and every one of this
we're going to create a file this one a
file this a file and so on and so forth
so let's take this off
there we go now getting back here once
we have had this in place I want to set
this up now recall that
we had created this create example meta
right here and if you notice you'll find
that in this year we are actually
um or this example is kind of like doing
exact same thing with discrete example
where we have those different features
which are created and then at the end we
have this serialized string meta which
is called so you could see here there's
different features see those features
and then they all combine to form the
example and then serialization so this
means that all we need to do here is
pass in we have here instead of this we
have create example and then we'll be
passing in the image and the level now
we'll take this off yeah we do not need
this basically we don't need that and
then we will go for image and level in
our data set now tensorflow data set
let's get back up the what we're doing
with now is our training data set so for
this
in our training they are set that's it
we're gonna write this so we're gonna
have to write
this image and this level in uh our file
will be creating so in our tensorflow
record file
now given that we are we have to write a
given chart and not just a full data set
yeah it would change we change this to
chart
that did a set and then let's have this
here we have our sharded data set which
is going to be equal
we have that uh training date is set and
then we'll Shard so we could get to the
definition or I could get to the
um tensorflow theater let's scroll this
tensorflow dealer this is set
here you could have this or you could
find this short method right here let's
scroll down and we click here you see we
have let's click on chart
okay so you see here we have the
definition takes the number of shards
and then it takes the specific index so
here we have 10 shards and then for each
index we're going to pass in the value
here dynamically so here you see that
this creates different uh packs or parts
of our data set so here we have each
pack which is going to be created so we
specify the number of shards there we go
and then we specify the sharp number so
that's all we need to create a part of
our data set so that's it once we have
this let's now run this and see what we
get we get in this error for sharded
number
uh run that again what do we get
um this very spaded one of time bytes so
what we pass in your stencil but we
expected a byte now the next question is
how do we convert this tensors to bytes
so we do a quick Google search here
convert image to bytes in tensorflow
there we go we have
um the code image but in fact what we'll
be using to convert this image into
bytes as this encode jpeg right here so
we haven't jpeg images so we could use
this here
um using it is quite simple we'll just
simply pass in the image and then we'll
consider all this to be default values
so here we have uh encode jpeg and then
we're gonna create this encoder meta
here and code
um image takes in the image and the
level and then what we have here is that
we're gonna start by having getting the
image we'll say image is going to be the
encoded version so we have tf.io dot
encode
uh g pack that's it we pass in the image
and then we're gonna return the image
and the level so once we have this let's
add this code so let's run this and then
we're going to create a new encoded data
set encoder data set equal this we have
training data set
there we go we're gonna map encode image
that's it
um so that each and every time we want
to pass this into this uh file writer
we're gonna make sure that we have this
in the form of bytes so that it matches
up with this year with this uh feature
which is defined in our create example
method right here so we need to match
this up so that's set let's get back we
have uh encode encoded data set uh take
this off we run we have encoded data set
and we told that this image has type
float32 that doesn't match expected type
of unsigned end eight so what we need to
do here is we need to convert our image
first into this unsigned it so we have
here
now to get a solution we'll get into TF
image convert image D type such that we
could convert it's actually convert
let's get to C convert image D type so
as we're saying we could actually
convert our float32 to the unsigned end
so here all we need to do as you can see
here you see you you have the tensor and
then you have the G type specified so
that said let's copy this and we have
that anyway we're gonna we're gonna take
the default value for the saturation so
let's get back here
and then at the level of this or before
the encoding we're going to convert that
so here we have image
image equal that and then we pass in the
image here
so we have TF dot unsign int 8.
uh and eight and close that so that's it
um then set we can now let's run this
and run this again so you can see our
encoded data set see that works fine now
so we have our encoded data set and then
in your instead of having this uh we'll
call this encoded data set so we have
encoded data set and then we'll run this
and see what we get
value must be iterable so we must
convert this into an iterable data set
so to do this we just have your s numpy
iterator
we have as numpyard Trader we run that
again
we are getting here 255 hashtag ain't
been expected one of bytes of this error
is coming from our create example method
so let's get back to create example uh
everything looks fine but here we should
have a list so let's have this year
there we go
and run this again
and that's it
the creation of the different files now
are complete you could click open here
and you see we have all these 10
different charts
at this point what we could do is we
could save this files in the drive such
that we could use it next time for
training so let's go ahead and see how
we could make use of this for our
training process now what we want to do
here is to convert this back to a
tensorflow data set so we had our
tensorflow data set we converted it into
a tensorflow record like we see here
we've converted this into some different
tensorflow record files and now we want
to reconvert this into our tensorflow
data set
now to get this reconstructed data set
we are going to pass the different file
names in this TF record data set right
here so what we'll have here is this
list made of all these different file
names right here
so this list in essence let's call it l
will be our path which will format and
then we'll pass in this variable P for p
in range the number of shards
for being reasonable of charts let's
print out this l
run that and we get this list which is
made of all the different files here so
that said what we're gonna have here is
we're gonna copy this
we're gonna copy this here
and then simply replace this list with
it so we have this list now
let's have this we have this list now
and then we run this and get our
reconstructed data set but then we need
to parse this TF record or did it set
such that we could get our original data
which was in the form of the image and
the level where the image was an array
and the label was some integer
and so with that we have here par single
example method which we're going to make
use of which takes an example which is
basically what is contained in our
reconstructing data set takes an example
and
Burmese also split this into the image
and the level so right here we'll have
example and then we'll get the image
we have the image
that will make use of the decode jpeg
method so previously we encoded the Jeep
into gpec or we converted into bytes now
we're going to convert from bytes back
to the unsigned integer so here we have
the code g pack and then we're going to
pass in
the example image
so we have that image we specify number
of channels to be three now we have all
the set what we're left to do is specify
this feature description right here
nonetheless this feature description is
basically what we had in this create
example
and so yeah we have this dictionary
let's have this images levels your
images we have this dictionary which is
made of the images and the levels and
then we have the data types of the
images and the levels respectively so we
need to pass in this feature description
in this past single example method now
we have that always set to return our
output so we take example and we have
images and then example and we have
levels so what we're doing here is we
take an input example and then we're
breaking it up into the images into the
levels while uh converting these images
from the bytes back to the unsigned int
so we have that now let's run the cell
and then here we have our parsed our
parsed data set
there we go we have parse data set and
we have Recons data set
there we go we map this method here so
we have parse TF records uh parse TF
records so we have this method let's run
this that's fine and then let's see what
is contained in our parsed data set so
let's take a single value
and then print this out from that
I'll get in this error for I in this
let's run that and there we go as you
can see we have our input and then our
output level right here now the next
thing we could do is specify the batch
size so let's have this batch size here
we have our batch
uh configuration and then batch size
that's fine and then we could do some
prefetching so let's carry out the
prefetching uh let's just do auto-tune
Auto Tune
and then run this again
there we go now we should have 32
elements so let's look at our batch our
our parse data set
uh looks fine you see we have this four
different dimensions and then we have
our output here
so that's it
we now have our parsed data set and
we're ready to train so as we've seen
already
it's important for you to save this in
some location let's say for example in
the drive such that the next time when
you want to do training all you need to
do is start from here so all you need to
do is to reconstruct this so you just
come and reconstruct this data set you
will parse it and then you're good to go
with this parsed data set right here so
you no longer have to
um load all those images from memory and
all of that now before we move on you
should also note that while encoding the
image or while encoding the editor
that's the image and the level what we
could also do is take the arc Max of the
level so if you have a level so let's
suppose we have an input image like this
and then you have an output level uh say
0 1 0 instead of taking the constrain
the labels to be this we could take the
position with the highest value so the
this is zero one two so it tends to one
now if we have
0 0
1 then after getting the arc Max in this
case it's going to be two because here
we have zero position or first position
second position and this is the one with
the highest value so
um this is another way of encoding our
levels and that's what we're gonna do so
we will take this and we run again and
create uh
um data set or create a tensorflow
records and we are still going to run
this cells again so let's rerun this and
we have our parts data which you could
see here you see now it's uh different
from what we had before so now we have
the image we have the images and then we
have the levels then we could go ahead
and run the model we have the loss
function defined now the loss function
is a sparse category called cross
entropy and this is simply because
instead of the one hard notation that is
instead of representing our outputs like
this for example we converting them into
this single integer so like this one for
example would be two if we had uh one
zero zero then this will be zero if we
have 0 1 0 then this will be one so
we've seen already that when we have
this um this kind of outputs then we use
this parse categorical cross entropy and
so that's it we have the sparse accuracy
category called accuracy and now let's
go ahead and start with the training
so there we go you can see that training
has begun and we're training as we
usually do
so that's it for this section on
tensorflow records see you in the next
section
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
gonna look at other state-of-the-art
convolutional neural network based model
and talking about state-of-the-art
models 10 years ago in the imagenet
visual recognition challenge the alexnet
convolutional neural network beat all
state-of-the-art solutions
previously or before this alexnet
solution instead of the art methods
achieved a top error rate of or top five
percent annual rate of 30 25.3 percent
but with alexnet we dropped this error
rate to
15.3 percent now this is 25.2 this
breakthrough has led to a widespread
adoption of convolutional neural
networks in solving recognition tags
like this one and although today we
would hardly use this kind of uh model
that's to say the alexnet model we are
going to discuss this model because it
was a precursor to most of the modern
confidence we have today like the mobile
Nets dance Nets and efficient Nets that
said we are gonna see what makes or what
made the alexnet model so powerful the
alexnet model was first published in
this paper entitled image net
classification with deep convolutional
neural networks just from the title you
could get some
idea that this was one of the first
times conf Nets were used for this
imagenet challenge this paper was by
Alex christianski eliaseker and Jeffrey
E Henson
in the abstract the start by presenting
the results as you could see here on
test data they achieved top 1 on top
five error rates of 37.5 percent and 17
which is considerably better than the
previous state of the art now this model
was uh 60 million parameter model
composed of conf layers and Max pulling
layers with some final three fully
connected layers as we shall see in the
mod on the model section shortly now
your 1000 way soft Max because we have 1
000 classes they also try to reduce
overfeeding by implementing strategies
like drop out in data augmentation that
said you already discussed the data set
which was used uh obviously the image
net which is a 15 million labeled high
resolution uh image data set although
the finally used roughly 1.2 million
training images 50 000 validation and
150 000 for testing
then it's also important to note that
the images which we use for training
were down sampled to 256 by 256 images
as for the overall architecture as we
could see here we have the conf layers
followed by Max pulling layers sometimes
you see your comp layer Max pooling
conflare Max pooling then we have
several conf layers this Max pulling
layer and then we have three dense
layers you see here we have this dance
layer this dance layer and this final
dance layer weight a thousand way output
then another point to note here is given
that at the time many times the
non-linearity used was the tench or the
sigmoid let's get back to the stop here
you see here they talk about the
non-linearity which was used uh I'm just
here the
previously were the the mostly use the
tank or the sigmoid as they say here
but it turns out that after working with
the relu the relu if you can recall uh
we've seen this in the previous section
the relative is simply this function
which takes in a value X and then if x
is negative the value is zero if x is
positive it Remains the Same value so
basically we have x uh f of x f of x
here
which is a relu function which is zero
if x is less than zero and it is x if x
is greater than or equals zero so this
already function right here and what the
discovered was that the relu permitted
them to train your model much faster
than this previously used
non-linearities like the tangent of X so
as you could see here just after a few
ebooks just after uh let's say five
epochs the attain this training error
rate as compared to this other
non-linearity year so this is what we
get when we use the relu and this is
what we get when we use some other
non-linearity like the tange X
and it's important to note that till
date most uh conf Nets we build make use
of this
relation linearity
another thing that did to speed up the
training was to use multiple gpus then
the actual number of gpus they use here
is two and the device a method of
communication between these two gpus to
speed up calculation from here the
authors make use of this normalization
strategy for regularization known as a
local response normalization
and this memorialization strategy was
used alongside the relu non-linearity so
from here we have some inputs let's take
this shimatic from
this post by Akil Anwar
where it shows this even more clearly
here we have some input and then
we normalize it based on its
surroundings hence the term local
response normalization here he explains
that there is a inter Channel local
response normalization and there's
intra-channel local response
normalization here as you can see this
is uh between pixels of a given Channel
or neurons of a gearing Channel and here
this is inter channel so this is
carry out between pixels of different
channels
now that said the exact mathematical
formula used here is this one so here we
have a given neuron and then we divide
as value by this summation right here
which is the square of some neck
borrowing values and according to the
author's terms here you see this sort of
response normalization implements a form
of lateral inhibition so take note of
this
and is inspired by the type found in
real neurons creating competition for
big activities amongst neuron outputs
computed using different kernels
so this means that
if we consider this three neck boring
channels from oral industry neighboring
neurons from those three different
channels
if we take this particular neuron right
here and we try to normalize it or pass
it through a normalization layer given
that it is surrounded by this pixel
whose value is relatively High
because of this Square Tam right here
notice there's a square right here
meaning that you take this value say 1
divided some uh by some summation and
then you have this Alpha obviously you
have this K right here let's omit that
let's just put it right here we have
this alphar and then we have uh this
value square so obviously this would be
a function uh basically this will be
this value here so when you square this
value it means that this overall value
here will become very small hence the
term lateral inhibition and so for a
neuron to maintain a relatively high
value after going through this local
response normalization layer right here
it has to ensure that it has one of the
highest values among the surrounding
neurons
nonetheless this local response
normalization as compared to other
normalization techniques like the batch
normalization layer normalization and
the group normalization hasn't proven to
be very effective when it comes to
regularizing a neural network and it's
not used by modern confidence we had
seen in the previous sessions that the
pulling layers permit us down sample
information from the inputs such that as
we go deeper in the neural network we
have a reduced number of features
now on this paper they make use of this
pulling layer more specifically the max
pole layer
and the way it works is quite
straightforward so we suppose we have
this kind of input and then we have a
three by three max pool layer with uh
initially a stride of one
we're going to have here is we have this
uh positions which we're gonna fix here
let's get back and then fix some values
so let's say we have a value of one
two
and then all these other values if we
want to carry out the max pole operation
with a stride of one we'll start with
this year
you see and because it is Max pool we
have we're gonna pick the max of all
this so we have the highest values 11
and so here we're going to have 11 and
then the next thing we'll do is we are
going to shift this so we shift this
here
um since the stride of one we're gonna
go one step to the right and so we have
this now it's here
notice how we still pick out three by
three uh pixels let's not take this one
off so we've done the shift and now we
have this position we take the max here
the max here again is going to give us
11 so we have 11 here and then we're
gonna do another shift so from here
we're gonna take this here let's take
this off we'll do this other shift and
then we still have this the max here
again is going to be 11. so you see at
the stop we have eleven eleven eleven
and then from here we'll move on to this
next one so we will go downward
um One Step downward we'll have this
here
and the max here is going to be here's
11 still so we're gonna have 11 here
and they will move this way this way
will go downward and all of that so we
will move this way I think we should
have 11 still
the other way 11 uh we go downward you
still have 11. practically we will have
11 everywhere so we would have 11 and
you're 11. so this is going to be our
output from this input here after the
max pole operation
now when we modify this strike number
from one to two take this right number
from one to two as it was Illustrated in
the paper instead of having or instead
of moving through one step we move
through two steps so if we take this off
here
you would see that we'll start with this
so from the first one we're gonna get 11
so this was tried equal to so the first
one we get 11 and then from here instead
of moving just one step like previously
we had this here we have this here and
then we move one step now we're gonna
move two steps so we move this way
and then again we have 11 and then
instead of going one step downward we're
gonna go two steps downward and so we'll
end up
um here
and then we have a maximum of 11 and
then we go two steps again this way so
let's take this one off
take this one off we go two steps again
and then we get a maximum of 11 right
here
so as you could see
yeah when you talk of overlapping
pulling they actually use a stride of
two just as we have described and then
the founders to give them uh to give an
improvement in the results though these
improvements aren't very
much so in practice we generally use
um the classical Max pooling with s
equal wonders stride number equal one
and we also use two by two
Canal size so instead of using three by
three Canal sizes as you see here
most times or in modern confidence
generally use two by two pull in size
now getting back to the general
architecture we could see here that this
very first conf net has a kennel size of
11 by 11.
and although this kinds of canals permit
the network capture
much larger spatial context we'll see
that they are computationally much more
expensive compared to this canals with
smaller filter size and as we'll see in
subsequent sections the confidence
developed after this didn't use this
kind of large Canal sizes as they were
able to make use of this kinds of
smaller filters to still capture this
large spatial context the 11 by 11
filters capture then to overcome
overfitting the others make use of data
augmentation
and the drop out technique so you could
check out on our previous sessions where
we talk about this two different
techniques now that said you'll see here
the training details and then one very
interesting advantage of working with
the 11 by 11 Canal size filters is the
fact that we could have visualizations
like this so because those kennel sizes
are large enough we could visualize them
in this manner and then clearly from
here we see how our conf layer captures
this kind of low level features like
here we have a slanted line here we have
yeah mini slanted lines we have this
vertical line we have this
horizontal lines right here and then we
have this kind this checkerboard pattern
we have this colors sometimes dual
sometimes single color and so we'll see
how this first kind of layers parameters
capture low level features in this
section they discuss this record
breaking results as you could see we
have this top one error rate which
um for now or at that time was about
45.7 percent and then with this uh
curved net model this was dropped to
37.5 percent therefore the top five we
have a drop from 25.7 to 17 percent now
they also developed this other variant
which comes with an even better top five
uh error rate
of 15.3 percent and so as you could see
here we're moving from this previous
method that's a shift plus fvs which had
26.2 top five percent error rate to the
CNN which has 15.3 percent error rate
then in this section on qualitative
results we see here the different uh
inputs the correct levels and then what
the model predicts or the top five best
predictions see the model does well here
does well here uh correct correct
prediction uh yours wrong see it
predicts convertible when it's actually
a grill here it does uh the strongly
yeah it's also wrong but uh unlike your
this level doesn't even occur among the
top five best predictions and so that's
it for this breakthrough model we're
going to look at other confident models
in the next sections
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
going to discuss the vgg model
vgg actually stands for visual geometry
group and this was presented in the
paper by Karen simonyong and Andrew this
is a man entitled very deep
convolutional networks for large-scale
image recognition in the session we are
going to discuss different methods which
the authors of the vgg paper used to
drop the top one validation error rate
from
38.1 to
23.7 where this 38.1 was achieved by the
Breakthrough confident model which is
the alexnet model
now in the previous session in which we
treated the alexnet model and we saw the
power of working with conf Nets and
solving recognition tasks one thing we
could notice already or very clearly
from this model is that it's quite
shallow and so simulator and Andrews is
a man go even deeper with the vgg model
in this paper the authors investigate
the effect of The Confident of the
convolutional network depth on its
accuracy not those words depth and
accuracy so unlike the Alex net where
the depth is relatively small and is
actually a shallow Network here the
authors use a deeper con convolutional
neural network and
make use of smaller convolution filters
now recall with Alex net from the very
first layer we already had 11 by 11
filters and we argued that this helped
in capturing
large spatial dependencies now we'll
explain how it's possible for us to make
use of the smaller and more economical
convolutional filters while still
capturing large spatial dependencies
like the bigger 5x5 and 11 by 11 filters
will do to better understand why it's
better to work with two three by three
comp layers as compared to working with
a single 5x5 conf layer let's consider
the following examples so here we have
these three
um examples let's start with this first
one year so let's have this we'll start
with this part here and this one if you
notice is five by five so here you have
kernel size of five input size of 10 and
no padding dilation of one and stride of
one
so here we have this here and you can
see we have this output which is six by
six so you have the six by six output
and the way each and every pixel on the
output is Garden is quite simple you
have the kernel right here let's have
this kernel we have this kernel which
has been passed on a particular patch on
the input and then this produces the
outputs so simply take this kind of
values multiply by these values add them
up and then get this output
now this is uh the case of five by five
so the receptive field Spaniard is quite
great see we could get or we could
capture this information in this uh
patch in the input right here now for
the number of parameters you could
simply count this we have five times
five which is 25 parameters here we have
25 parameters and then uh for the
learning capabilities this one is quite
limited here here we have 25 and here
we'll say this is quite limited because
if we suppose that we have an input
let's say we have this input which is
passed through a single conf layer and
then obviously the conflict layer ends
with a non-linearity in our case the
real own linearity so let's say we have
the non-linearity right here and then we
get the output now
this doesn't capture as much complex
information
as we would be able to capture if we had
two conf layers stacked now here when
you stack this first one this is a case
of three by three and this is a case of
five by five so here after this first
three by three we then have this other
three by three with this other
non-linearity so here we are able to
capture much more complex information
from our input information of my input
data as compared to when we just have
one single conf layer so that's why your
let's take this off here we the the
learning capabilities isn't as much as
this to three by three now let's get to
the receptive Fields pan for the two
three by three to understand this we are
going to take this example right here so
take note that here we have input size
of 10 so we're going to maintain this we
have input size 10 okay now the candle
size is three unlike here where we had
five uh patient dilation and stripe
number the same now notice that the
output we have here is eight by eight
unlike your aware of six by six now
since we are having two three by three
con layers we're gonna get this output
just like the output we get here is this
so let's draw let's put this here we
have this input the here is it and then
we get this output which is going to be
input of another three by three so this
is the first three by three and then
this is the next three by three so this
will be the input of another three by
three curve layer and then we should
produce the output so what we're trying
to show here is when we have this output
here which is the input of this next
layer so this is this two here are
combined as one this forms one so
um this here this eight by eight now is
the input so here instead of having 10
we have eight so we have the example
size of eight there we go same kind of
size patterns dilations try the same and
what we want you to notice let's take
this off what I want you to notice here
is the fact that this output is six by
six and so this means that this year
let's if we follow this uh let's take
the mouse if we follow you see this here
captures the same information as you
would uh as this one year would capture
and so uh we could confidently see that
the recessive feels spanier is quite
great now for the number of parameters
here we have nine and here we have nine
nine plus nine is eighteen so eighteen
I'll go put here 18. you see clearly
that this model now is cheaper as
compared to a model which uses a five by
five or even 11 by 11. now for the
learning capabilities we've seen this
already because we stack two we're able
to capture much more complex information
from the inputs and so this is great so
uh in all we see that is better to use
this
conf layers with smaller Canal sizes we
want to thank Edward young for providing
this convolution visualizer which you
can find on asean.github.io
so at this point we've understood why
the authors of this paper prefer to work
with this smaller kennel size
convolutional layers that's three by
three
and with the smaller account flares they
were able to push the depth uh to 16
that's between 16 and 19.
layers where the 16 layer version is vgg
16 and then the 19 layer version is vgg
19.
in this table we have the summary of
this models here would focus on the 16
and 19 weights or layer models so here
we have 16 oh wait layers you see we
start with two count layers and then Max
pool and then two con flares and the max
pool and then three comp layers Max pool
three con players Max pool and then
three conf layers then from here we have
the max pool we have a flattening layer
and then we have this three fully
connected layers which
end up with a soft Max since we're
dealing with a multi-class
classification problem
the authors also noted that the usage of
the rrn normalization that's a local
response normalization which we saw in
the Alex net did not improve performance
but inside led to increased memory
consumption and computation time in the
section the describe the training
process then from your testing and we
could get some results
and here you see we have this top one
validation error and we also notice that
we have this uh component layer or this
component model here a now the a b c d e
you could get them by uh checking on
this table here you have a uh a with the
lrn normalization b c d and e right here
so basically these are those uh
different models and your other their
results so walking with the with the
local response normalization we notice
that this seems to have even the highest
error so that's why the authors did not
make use of this uh normalization
technique now we get the best results
with the vgg 19 so this the this year
and the vision 19 uh we get 25.5 for top
one and then eight for top five now if
you're new to this notion of top one
about error and top five Vault error you
could check called the previous session
where we discussed the top one accuracy
and top five accuracy here again now we
have this comparison with the state of
the art of solutions at the time you see
here Alex net over feet uh Inception uh
msra clarify this this model by clarify
Ai and zealer and fergus's model so here
we see that the vgg has uh at the time
had the best results and with this we
can conclude that
um stacking up those kind of layers with
smaller Canal size actually helps in
getting better better results and in
subsequent sections we'll see the limit
of just stacking up many conf layers as
with the vgg
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
gonna discuss the resnet model this
model was first introduced in this paper
entitled deep residual learning for
image recognition by coming here out and
up to date that's about seven years
later this model is still greatly used
and the high performance is Garden when
working with the resnet model come due
to the fact that the Redstone model
relies on this residual block right here
which permits us get even better error
rates as we could see here as compared
to the vgg and Google net models in this
section we are going to focus on
understanding how this residual block
works and how the resonant model is
constructed based off this model this
curves right here depict the limit of
models like the video G which are just
based on stacking up conf layers
to best understand this plot recorded
with the Alex net we had fewer number of
layers so we have we started out with
alexnet a few animal layers and then we
moved on to vgg where we had the vgg 16
version
than the vgg 19 version and then we
expect that if we keep increasing this
number of layers then the error rates
should be dropping but what happens
actually is the opposite so what goes on
here is you see for those 20 layer
Network we have a lower error rate as
compared to this 56 layer Network so we
expect that this instead should be
lowered in this because this will
stacked and we've stacked more count
layers but that's inside the opposite
now this uh same phenomenon is witnessed
with the test set so here there's a test
and there's a training so for the test
tool we have the 20 layer performing
better than the 56 layer
and so it's clear that just blindly
stacking up kind of layers wouldn't
help in making this or in dropping the
training on test errors even though they
are more expensive
and this is why the resnet model
introduces this residual learning which
is based of the residual block which
you've seen already here's the residual
block
now note that this weight layer here all
those with layers here are simply
convolutional layers
and so now unlike before where we'll
just stack this here let's let's let's
call this WL for weight layer stack this
weight layer and then we'll stack this
other one and then we'll keep stacking
up that way
just keep stacking up like this now what
we'll do is we create a connection
between the input and the output
so we create this connection and then
here there's some addition so we get
this output and we add it with this
other output right here to produce now
this new output so you have to suppose
that this input is X and then what goes
on in here is f of x so let's change
this to Red what goes on in here is f of
x that's this
f of x here we have this f of x then our
output can be given as h of X which is
simply equal f of x
plus X that's the input plus its output
now to produce this new output h of x
but again to better understand why
we need this residual block right here
we need to First understand why models
which are based on just stacking up the
count layers like the vgg actually under
fit even when you add up or when you
increase the number of layers now the
reason for that is
exploding and or varnishing ingredients
so let's uh explain what it means for
our gradients to be Vanishing now recall
that in the gradient design process we
have a weight
and this weight the way this weight is
updated is such that we take its
previous value so we have the previous
value of the weight
minus the learning rates here let's call
it rlr generally denoted Alpha minus
this learning rate times the partial
derivative of the loss with respect to
that given weight
now during the training process in order
to compute this partial derivative right
here very efficiently the method used is
back propagation or one of the most
common methods used is that of back
propagation now the way back propagation
works is that you have saved this model
let's call this model M and then you
have some input right here with the
output obviously you have what the model
outputs and let's let's call the model
output y cup and then uh y That's not
model we have y right here which is what
the model is expected to Output now is
this difference that produces the loss
and while finding that partial
derivative of this difference
with respect to each and every weight
which makes up this model
then if we split this up into different
layers let's just say we have different
layers like this note that each layer is
composed of several uh weights but let's
let's say we just split this up like
this now the layers this layer has its
own weights but one point to note is
that during the back propagation process
to obtain the partial derivative of the
loss with respect to this width year we
make use of the partial derivative of
the loss with respect to weights
which come after the layer or which come
after this layer right here so we to get
this year we will need this different
partial derivatives
to get uh let's let's get back
uh let's get back to get this for
example to get the partial derivative
with respect to this weight here we will
need this others right here
now the problem is if we have this year
and and also before before going to
explain the the problem with this is
that we need to understand that
to get for example let's take this one
to get for example the partial
derivative of the loss with respect to
this different weights there are many
weights in this layer let's say wait for
this layer uh it's actually equal uh
some values let's say alpha 1 times
whatever value times
of this partial derivative of the loss
we respect to this weights here so
let's consider that this is the sit
layer one two three four five six then
L6 here we have L7 layer seven so
because we're multiplying here it means
that if a while getting this uh partial
derivative we obtain a value very close
to zero if we get a value very close to
zero say uh
0.00001 for example it means that it's
going to affect this other partial
derivative in the sense that this two
will be a very small value and if this
partial derivatives are too small then
we will not get a change in this weight
because you have the the new way you're
trying to get being equal the previous
weight minus a very small value here and
so there will be no there'll be little
or no changes in the weights and
that is why even lawyer you keep
increasing those number of layers let's
take this off even though we keep
increasing this number of layers we
cannot achieve better performances due
to this Vanishing gradient problem as
the model is now finding it difficult to
update its weights such that the
training error can be decreased since
the gradients right here are Vanishing
that is they are getting towards zero so
now we've just seen that making our
Network deeper or increasing the number
of layers
makes it difficult to propagate
information from one far end to the
other end
and so what the authors suppose is that
if the added layers can be constructed
as identity mappings a deeper model
should have training error no greater
than its shallower counterpart so this
means that you have this model let's
suppose this model and then we this is
the shallower model and then this is the
deeper model right here
I will say that if we construct this
deeper model such that it's identical to
the shallower model so basically it's
the same as this here it changes in blue
so we have this same shallower model and
then the remaining layers here those
other layers here are constructed such
that this is the identity
function or a group of identity
functions which are stacked together
then the training error of this one
although deeper shouldn't be greater
than this training error right here or
the training error of this shallower
model
and so this means that if we want to
pass information from this point to this
point right here and that those weights
or the values in your
dampen this information
then there is this path right here which
permits us
simply copy this input information to
the output
and obviously this is simply the
identity function and so here if after
passing through say 20 layers and we get
to this point so let's consider each and
every one of this is a single layer so
we've gone through 20 layers and then
we've gotten to this point where the
values we get here are almost zero such
that when this information passes it's
going to be also uh or practically zero
then there is this path which at least
restores this exact same input we have
here and so this means that just as the
authors of the papers supposed in this
example we took here
if we make our model or neural network
Zipper by adding this residual blocks
then
there will be no increase in the error
rate
and in practice this instead leads to a
decrease in the error rate which is
exactly what we want
and one other argument which accounts
for the fact that this residual blocks
help in improving the performance of the
model is the fact that since we have
several parts this residual model now
looks like a combination of several
shallow models so it looks like you're
combining different let's let's draw it
better let's get back it looks like
we're combining this shallow model
here with this other shallow model
with this other shallow model and then
producing what we call an ensemble of
models or an ensemble of shallow models
to be more precise which help in making
the overall model much more performance
as compared to when we just have a
single path
so another way you could look at this is
that for this let's take this first
shallow model you could have information
which passes this way and then gets here
and then goes this way so that's the
first model and then another time you
could have information which goes this
way uh goes this way goes this way and
you have this other model you can have
an understation where the model goes uh
this way it goes this way and then goes
just straight and giving us this other
model
later uh in this paper entitled
visualizing the Lost landscape of neural
Nets Li a Al
produced this visualization here which
shows a resnet without skip connections
and a resnet with skip connections and
this shows how
easy it is or how easy it is for the
weights to find their way or to get the
optimal weights which minimize the loss
as compared to when there are no skip
connections here it should also be noted
that this addition we have here is an
element-wise addition
and so we have to ensure that the
dimensions of this input should match
the dimensions of the output we have
here for this operation to be valid now
the cases where on the case where these
two aren't equal then we need to do some
modifications in this skip connection
right here
now when we look at this uh three models
compared we have this vgg 19 we have
this 34 layer uh plane or
convolutional Network then we have this
34 layer residual Network we find that
we have this skip connections that's our
residual block so this is our residual
block right here we stacked this
residual blocks now instead of just
stacking uh the conf layers as we do
with the vggs now we stack there is drop
blocks and then sometimes you could see
here sometimes this line is solid
sometimes it is dotted now when it's
dotted like this it's simply because
there's going to be a change in the
dimension so if you notice here you'll
find that uh every time we have this
dotted lines you'll find that there's a
change here the number of channels so
here you have 64 channels and then here
you have a 128.
and so since we're getting this 64
Channel input and we want to match this
with 128 output we get in here then we
need to do some adjustments here now as
with uh senior or as you can see in the
paper here there are actually two ways
of making this adjustments the first way
is this a the next one this is B for the
a the shortcuts still perform identity
mapping with extra zero entries padded
for increasing the dimensions so to get
from 64 to 128 we add this extra zero
entries
then Addai we do that all we uh take the
B that's the projection shortcut
which was presented in equation two is
used to match the dimensions but this is
actually done uh using one by one
convolutions
now to better understand how the one by
one convolutions work let's take this
example where we have this input size 10
by 10 cannot size now since it's one by
one then the candle size is one so this
is we have just this one weight right
here and then you see it just goes
through each and every uh pixel value so
here we have this and then notice that
the input
is the same shape as the output
and so if for example you have this
input made of two channels let's add a
second Channel let's suppose this input
has two channels so we have this one
channel and this other channel right
here
then uh to obtain an output of say four
channels so we have this input two
channels so it's 10 by 10 by 2 to
channels and if we want to have this
output to go get to four channels all we
need to do now is just make use of the
one by one convolution and then we add
the or we have four of this different uh
weights or those four four of these
different kernels since it's obviously
one by one if we're three by three then
we'll have something like this would
have uh three of the or four of this now
is one by one we have is here four of
this and then in that case this one will
give this output then this other one
will give this other channel your
this Auto One let's change the color
this other one
will give another Channel which will
just add here
then this other one here
stick that to be green
will produce this other channel so
that's how we can move from these two
channels to four channels and so uh in
the case of the resnets where we want
the inputs again some inputs uh let's
say 64 Channel input and we want that at
the end
uh we want that this input what we have
here should match with this output which
is already 128
oh yeah 128 here then we need or we
could add this one by one convolutions
with a certain number of filters such
that we could get this desired number of
channels here so here now we could have
um
128 one by one filters and then this now
will match up with this output right
here such that we could carry out the
element wise Edition
another difference with the vgg and
other previous account Nets is that
instead of making use of the max pool as
you will have here you see the spooling
layer with pool size two what we do here
is we use uh our three by three
convolutional layer but we use Stripes
so we specify the strike number of two
and this premise are to down sample this
uh feature Maps right here
again we could check this out here let's
suppose we have this three and if we're
to do uh or if we want to down sample
this what we could do is increase the
number of strides let's take that to two
and you see this is going to be down
sample and if we take the padding to one
you find that the output is half of what
we have here then the authors also make
use of augmentation and then batch
normalization where the apply this batch
normalization layer right after each
convolution and before the railroad
activation
now biased normalization is this
technique for accelerating deep neural
network training by reducing internal
covariate shift
to better understand rationalization
we'll start by explaining the notion of
covariate shift
to better understand the notion of
covariate shift let's suppose that we're
trying to build a model which classifies
or which says whether an input image
like this one or say this one is that of
a car so it's all I call or it is not a
car
now if you're building this kind of
system and then you start by or you
create batches of these kinds of toy
cars and you pass through the model and
model learns how to see this and know
that it's a car and since some other
image and knows that that's not a car
then later on when you take a car from
this other distribution and you pass
into our system
it becomes difficult for the weights of
this model to adapt to this change in
distribution though the inputs are all
cars
and to visualize this let's consider
this plot right here
what we're gonna have is uh something
like this so we'll have this year for
car and then this for not car
and then we'll build this classifier or
this model which distinguishes a car and
an image which is not a car by say this
function for example
now when you bring some other
distribution like say this distribution
you would have uh something like this
you see you have something like this
here this other
um
distribution
and not car let's say not cars are about
this
and then you need to have something like
this to separate the cars from images
which are not cars
and this then makes it difficult for us
to have a function which separates uh
images which are cars from those which
are not cars when those images come from
these two different distribution
now this shift year is known as the
covariate shift
and so that's why most times before
passing the image into the model what we
do is we normalize this input so let's
suppose we have an input X we generally
carry out some normalization in order to
account for this covariate shift so now
after normalization what we're gonna
have is that all these images be from
this distribution or this other
distribution right here will now
have been normalized to reduce the
effect of the shift and so now we could
have our single or could have this R uh
function which separates
the cars from the non-cars
and with much more ease
now that said what if this kind of
covariate shift instead happens in the
hidden layers that's these layers which
make up the model right here so let's
suppose that we have some confidence
like this stacked with the activation
functions and then
we have this weights that's this
parameters which make up oh which are
part of the layer now coming from
different distributions
then in this case we have an internal
covariate shift
and to remedy this situation we now make
use of the batch normalization
and the algorithm for the batch
normalization is describing the paper so
here we have a mini batch and we obtain
its mean so here we try to obtain the
average value of the different weights
then we also obtain the standard
deviation
which is Sigma and the variance which is
Sigma Square so basically we obtain the
mean and we obtain the variance and it's
this that we make use now to normalize
our data so now you take every weight
you subtract by the mean that's here
which is calculated here and then you
divide by this uh standard deviation
and then we add the small Epsilon to
avoid having a very small number or zero
at the denominator
so that's it uh this is how the
normalization or the batch normalization
process goes on
and it should be noted that there are
other normalization techniques like the
layer and group normalization which are
kind of similar to this but uh different
in a sense that with a batch
normalization this mean is calculated
over a given mini batch so like here
this is the mean of values calculated in
a minute batch and the standard
deviation from that mini batch now uh
after getting this uh new value of x x
Shuffle uh what we now do is we multiply
it by gamma and add better now those
gamma and better are actually trainable
parameters so when working with um batch
normalization in say tensorflow or Pi
torch you'll notice that the batch Norm
layer will also have its parameters now
here the role of this gamma and this
better is to skill and shift and this
parameters are learned along with the
original model parameters and restore
the representation power of the network
and so when we set gamma to be the
square root of the variance and beta to
be this to be the expectants or the mean
of X then we could recover the original
activations if that were the optimal
thing to do
so essentially what this thing here is
if it's instead optimal for us not to
use the batch normalization then we
could adapt the value of gamma and
better such that we get this original
value of extra year and the way this can
be done is quite simple
all we need to do here
is multiply this x by let's say gamma
square plus Epsilon so we have gamma
square plus Epsilon
and then div I'll
once we've multiplied this you see once
you stick this here I multiply by this
you set this to like this do this this
cancels out with this and you're left
with x i minus the mean now when you
level X I minus mean if beta is equal to
mean then you will have x i
minus the mean
Plus
beater which in this case is the mean
and you see it cancels out and gives you
x i which is this original value of x so
if we set our beta to be this or rather
our gamma to this and our bidder to be
the mean then in that case we retrieve
our original value of x and so that's
why you see those two parameters are
trainable such that we get the best
values or the most optimal values for uh
gamma and beta
then there's also this uh initialization
that's uh the model or the the network
is trained from scratch stochastic
gradient descent is used with a mini
batch size of 256 learning rate starts
from 0.1 and just divided by 10 when the
error plateaus so basically uh when we
get to the point where let's have this
when we get to a point where the arrow
starts to Arrow starts to Plateau then
at that point we could update the
learning rate from 0.1 to
0.01 and then if it plateaus if it drops
you see any plateaus like let's go this
way it drops and plateaus again then we
carry out this uh same computation
now that said is for over 60 times 10 to
the four iterations with Decay and
momentum I used and there is no use of
drop out so uh again uh in testing here
we have uh different skills which are
used and average so we pass the image at
these different skills and then the
average value of the average course uh
recorded now before we move forward to
check out some results it's important to
note here that after this last uh conf
layer we do not carry out flooding and
so what is done here is average pulling
in order to better understand how the
global average pooling Works let's
consider this example from peltarian.com
so right here we supposing that we have
this as the output of the final count
layer then what we do is instead of just
flattening that's just picking all those
values and flattening them out and then
passing to a fully connected layer what
we are going to do is
um depending on the number of neurons we
want the next fully connected layer we
are going to create a certain number of
channels so here for example we have
this depth here the number of channels
here is three we have the height and we
have the width and then since we're
dealing with we're actually doing global
average pulling then for each and every
one of these channels for this channel
this Channel and this channel we're
gonna get the average value so yeah the
average value is this eight you have the
average value is a three yeah the
average value is this five and so if you
want a thousand of this then uh you
should have a depth of a 1000 right here
and now with this you see that it looks
quite similar to the flattened layer as
now you have all these different values
all these different uh single values
which can now be passed into a fully
connected layer
now it should be noted that in certain
tasks like in classification which we
are trying to do this uh global average
Boolean
will be great as the position of the
pixels don't really matter
now this simply means that you're since
you get this average and here you get
this average you get this average it
means that this uh position
or this pixel wouldn't be close to this
other pixel
as in the case of the flooding
but since like in our case we're
interested in seeing whether a person is
angry
happy
or sad the positions of this output
values right here won't really matter as
much as would would have mattered in the
case where we're dealing with an object
detection or say object counting problem
where the particular position of the
person or of whatever we are trying to
detect actually counts so to better
explain this again let's consider these
two examples example one example two
right here for classification problems
are we interested in detecting that this
person is happy so whether we have a
face this way or this way the position
doesn't really matter all we're
interested is in knowing whether this
person is Happy angry or sad
now for object detection the exact
position of the person matters and so
the exact position of this neurons here
will matter and so employing global
average pooling for such tasks isn't a
great idea so in summary
um if you have a task where the position
doesn't matter that much then you could
use a global average pulling if not then
you advise to use the flattened layer
from here you could see the different
variants of the resnet you see here we
have the 18 layer resnet as a resnet 18
resnet 34 resnet 50 resnet 101 resnet
152 and here we could see that with the
plane networks that's without the rest
residual block you find this 18 layer
performing better than the 34 layer but
once we have the resnet block you find
the 34 layer performing now better than
the 18 layer meaning that we could now
go deeper we also have this table right
here which shows the vgg model the
Google net the prlu unit and then the
different plane networks and the
residual networks it shows clearly here
that the resnet 150 performs best
regardless of the fact that it is deeper
than the 101 and 50 counterparts and
before we move on also note that here
this resnet block as you can see here is
composed of these two comp layers for
the 34 layer while from this 50 of to
150 layers the resonant blocks are
composed of three layers or three conf
layers as you could see right here
hello everyone and welcome to the
session in which we are going to
implement the code for resnet34 in
tensorflow 2. now here is a resnet34
model right here we have all the
variants like the 50 101 and 152. after
going through the Section you'll be able
to implement this other variance right
here and also you'll be able to get
results like this where we can see
clearly an improvement in the accuracy
of our model we are going to construct
our resnet34 model while making use of
model subclassen so you could check out
on the previous sections so you better
understand how model subscribing is
implemented in tensorflow 2. now that
said here we have this resnet34 model
right here
and then the first uh layer we have is
our convolutional layer which has seven
by seven filters and there are 64 in
number
also we note that the stridier number of
strides equal two so you could get all
this from the paper we have the
information from the paper 7x7 64 strike
two and then followed by a three by
three max pool with a stride of two so
we get back here we have this three by
three stride of two
now from this we then get into this
residual blocks so uh we'll get back to
the paper you see we have three of this
residual blocks now let's it's actually
this because this is a 34 layer we're
implementing right here but in that if
you are implementing a 50 layer resnet
then you would have one by one three by
three and one by one but for the 34
version we have three by three and three
by three now this uh repeated twice so
that's why you will notice here we have
this repeated three times and each one
of them is our residual block now our
residual block here our residual block
is this block right here so we are going
to later on Implement implement this
residual block here let's get back to
the code we have simply already draw a
block you see the parameters here
number of filters 64 64 and your 64.
just exactly as we have it in the paper
you see for each block we have number of
filters to be 64. now if we want to get
into uh or introducers to a block we
could oh what we would see exactly how
it's implemented and would see that
we're gonna have these two conf layers
one three by three and another three by
three but for now let's uh do it this
way let's just consider that that has
been implemented now another reason why
I want to implement this is this way is
because now if you want to convert this
to a resnet 50 all we need to do now is
just to update the code for the residual
block since or what makes this different
here is just this uh residual blocks
right here so that's set let's get back
again here we have now
this uh four resonant blocks so we have
these four residual blocks actually
oh yeah you see you have oh this is four
and it's similar like here you have the
three by three three by three and then
here the number of channels equal 128.
so you'll notice here that we have 128
and we have four of them now because uh
here we're living from or we modifying
the number of channels we need to take
into consideration this number of
strides we have right here as this
permits are still down sample our
features now getting back to the code
you have this year uh over here we have
the down sampling and then we move on
128 128 128 again here we have down
sampling now we go to 256 exactly as is
in the paper okay we could look at this
directly from here here we have 256 and
we have
um a certain number of them which are
aligned we could see that in the summary
here six of them check this out here
here
you see we have six of this aligned and
then again we have 512
three of them as is in the paper you see
here 512 and that's it now from here we
have the global average pulling to the
global average pulling and then we have
this final fully connected layer which
with an activation which is soft Max as
we've seen previously now that said uh
we just in this are called matter we're
just simply gonna uh call all those
different
layers which we just created by passing
in the input so here we have our input X
which goes through each and every layer
and we get the output right here
now that's set we're going to move on to
uh looking at this residual block right
here so we're going to implement this
residual block
and now this is basically our residual
block let's increase this so we could
see that clearly this is basically our
residual block right here so we could
take one of this let's let's take this
one for example we have this residual
block right here and then we get back to
the code see it here now this is always
do our block it's a layer unlike the
full model here we have this residual
layer and then you'll see that we have
this
um dotted
bullying right here which is true when
the number of Stripes is driven from one
so let's uh run this year let's let's
have this we have dot tet and then let's
specify number of strides say equal one
we let's print out dotted after this so
there we go we have your dotted we run
this let's take this off see it's false
now when we set this to 2
turns to true so basically that's what
dotted your does and if you get back
you'll notice that we let's get back to
this we have this we selected this part
but since this is this isn't a dotted uh
link see this link is a full line so
here our dotted variable will be false
and when we get to this or the other
variable will be true now let's get back
to the code you see we have let's take
this off you see here we have
um this we should understand already and
I'll get back here then after we have
our two convolutional layers now we'll
Define this custom com 2D which again we
are going to break up uh subsequently so
let's just understand that we have this
custom curve to D which is represented
by this uh year so when we have this
this is uh it right here and this is the
other one right here now you'll notice
that the number of channels has been
passed here and the number of strides
has also been passed and that's exactly
what was done here so you see we passed
in the number of channels and number of
trites now since by default our number
of strides is equal one it means when we
don't pass we simply say number of
stride equal one but in cases where we
have this transitions we have number of
strikes equal two and so our value here
is going to be changed now that said we
see we Define this conf layer which has
number of channels no kennel size three
as in the paper number of strides and
then we have the pattern same so we
ensure that the height and width of our
input features remain unchanged now that
said
also notice that we have this number of
strides here for the second which is
equal one and getting back to the paper
that's simply because even when we're
getting uh even when we have these
transitions here where we're getting
from 64 to 128 and that we're also doing
the max pulling we have this try uh
rather that we have in the striding not
Max pulling we have this stride value
change for only one of the conf layers
and not the two so you see here only one
another two and so that's why right here
you see it's only this one which
actually changes for this other one it
remains fixed always one now that said
we have the activation layer and then uh
if is dotted then we're gonna have this
link right here so if it's dotted we're
gonna have uh let's draw this here we're
gonna have uh one by one conf layer uh
one by one oh it's actually a year so
we're gonna have our one let's take this
one off
we're gonna have our one by one conf
layer just right here to ensure that
this two number of channels match that's
the number of channels we get as input
here and as output actually match up so
um that's the role of this we've seen
this already now we get back to the code
we see here let's take this off we see
here this year and then we see the
number of the the kernel size here is
one unlike here where we have a kind of
size of three and then we also specify
the number of channels to ensure that it
matches up with uh what we expect now
the number of strides here is gotten
from this so it's two you're gonna have
two if it's one you're gonna have one
from here we have uh this set
and then we can go ahead and do the
calling so again please check out on the
previous sessions where we treat models
of class and so you understand exactly
what's going on so here we have uh the
input we see the input it gets into the
first conf layer then gets to the second
kind of layer that's the output from the
first gets as input to the second and
then we get this output and now let's
suppose that uh we have a normal layer
let's say we're having this one
get back to this let's suppose that we
are working with this one right here in
that case then the input will be added
to the output directly so here you see
we have this add layer right here let's
add layer intensorflow it takes the
output which is this and adds this to
the input and we now get X add it goes
to the activation the relu and that's
our output now in the case where we have
this in the case where we have this one
by one convolutional layer let's specify
this in the case where we are at this uh
position then you'll see that we will
take the input and modify it before
passing it to the output or before
adding it with the output so you see
here we have this output there we go it
remains here and then we modify this or
we modify this input sorry so we take
this input there's there's it here
let's take all this off and try to
redraw it so we have this we have our
red block and then we have our output we
have the addition which is going to be
right here
addition and then we're gonna have our
one by one conf layer right here which
comes in answer with this now this one
by one convolution is exactly what's
going on right here and that's what we
defined here since kennel size one
now that said you see we add this up and
then uh we get our output X add so if we
are having dotted we have that else we
go through the normal path and that's
basically why you see here we specify
this sometimes and we don't in other
times
now we have understood how this works
let's go ahead to look at the custom
conf 2D layer now the custom comes to
the layer is basically made of a usual
account to the layer and with the batch
number remember the resnet model or the
resnet paper makes use of the batch
normalization layer so basically here
instead of writing by this number every
time no code what we just want to do is
combine this two and then we have our
batch normalization we all come to the
layer together so that's it we now run
the cell
there we go we run the cell
we again run the cell
and then we can Define IRS net 34 which
is our resnet model which we've just
seen resnet 34 there we go we
um have the resnet 34 uh summary
let's run this
we get this error we need to build our
model so what we're going to do here is
quite simple
we will not take this rest net 34 and
then we'll call this uh resident 34. so
we will pass in some inputs into this
resident 34 model so here we'll suppose
tf0s and then we have one by 256 by 256
by three so we have this kind of input
we run that and we see that now we have
our model so our model summary so this
is our model summary 21 million uh
parameters and that's it now we go to
the training but this time around we're
going to include some checkpointing so
we got this from our previous session
where we treated checkpointing the model
checkpointing so here we're gonna ensure
that as we train
we save our best model weights
so that said
here we have this checkpoint call back
again you could check back on our
previous sessions where we treat this
callbacks so here we have this callback
which will permit our style to wait for
our best or our best performing model
our best performing weights actually so
here we have a monitor we're going to
monitor the validation accuracy so let's
take this off
my intervalization accuracy save this
best only true so that's it let's run
this our loss function but before we
move on let's get back to the section
where we had this parameter training
right here now we have this uh custom
curve to the model let's delete the
cells we have this custom curve to the
model which we've seen already and then
we have this batch Norm layer but it
should be noted that with the batch Norm
layer we have
to specify whether we are in training
mode or in inference or testing mode now
the reason why we are doing this is
because the parameters of our batch Norm
layer will react differently or
behave differently in these two
different modes this means that during
training
this layer will normalize the inputs
with the mean and variance of the
current batch of inputs now we'll see
this already and then uh when we're not
training that's when training equal
false we're in inference mode the layer
will normalize its input using the mean
and variance of its moving statistics
learned during training so this simply
means that we have this layer right here
with some parameters let's call the
parameters say uh P let's call it
parameters P so you have some parameters
right here
and then doing training our our layer
Updates this parameters but then during
inference we do not want to update these
parameters as
they will learn during training and so
we have to specify or we have to pass in
the training or set the training to
false when we are not training the model
or when we are evaluating or testing the
model
now what this simply means is that year
would have this to training so you
already see with pass and training and
then here we have training so by default
we could set this training to true so by
default in training mode and that's what
we have now let's run the cell and then
get into our residual block for this dot
block here
we have training again so we have
training and then uh since we're calling
this we'll have training there we go we
have training
and that's it we have training
let's run this we get back to our
complete Network
and here we're gonna have this training
so we paste that out here and that
should be fine so now when we are not in
training mode we could specify those
training parameters such that the batch
Norm layer of the batch Norm layers
parameters aren't modified
so we have that and that's it okay so we
have that set now let's run this
and this time around we're going to set
this training so let's set training to
be uh true we have that true let's make
sure that this was passed in here so
let's have this training and the default
is true okay we're on that we run this
and that looks fine now we could set
this to be false or we don't we don't
put any value it means it's true so we
set this to be false
training to be false and that's it
so there we go we have the set now let's
get back to our loss function so we were
at this point we have our Matrix We Run
The Matrix we compile the model but the
samurai will use a Higher Learning rate
so uh one thing you could also do is as
describing the paper decrease this
learning rate as soon as the model
starts plateauing so we could start with
a learning rate in the paper it should
be 0.1 although here we're going to
start with 0.01 so yeah the say you you
have this learning rate and then when it
says plateauing you drop uh to
0.01 and then you go with that and then
start plateauing you drop and so on and
so forth so this is what uh the proposed
in the paper and you could always
implement this and we'll send this in
some previous section where we
implemented this kind of callback which
permitted us to schedule our learning
rate so that's it let's take this off
get back to the code and we have uh we
found this already so we could start
with the training
now here we're gonna train
for 60 ebooks and we're going to include
the call Max so let's have this
callbacks and we have our model
checkpoints callback which we have
defined here let's copy this there we go
copy this and we have it here
so that's it we can now run the cell
now we've launched this training I've
had this error here save the model to
the hdf5 format requires the model to be
a functional model or a sequential model
it does not work for subclass models
like in our case because such models are
defined we are the body of a python
method which isn't safely serializable
hence consider saving to the tensorflow
saved format by setting say format to TF
or using save weights so now we're going
to save this models in the tensorflow
format all we need to do here is specify
this folder and that should be fine the
mode is Max now since we want to store
the weights which have the highest
validation accuracy that's fine let's
now run this again
train now complete and we achieve an
accuracy of the best accuracy of
83.6 percent
we have our accuracy plot right here and
then we could evaluate the model
here we get 82.3 percent and 94.6 for
the top K accuracy now what if we load
our best model because the model we have
in here is the latest model the very
last one now let's load our best model
and re-evaluate this let's add this code
cell
then we go ahead and load our best
weights here we have resnet 34
um the load weights then here we have
our best weights so this should be a
string since it's our folder there's a
folder where we start the weights uh res
net we run this
that's fine and then we evaluate our
model
see here we get in this uh accuracy
of 83.6 and then top key accuracy of
95.6 percent
now uh we go on to test this
that's fine and
here are some results we get uh Happy
angry sad happy you'll miss we miss one
we missed this one uh that's two three
and
and that's it so we missed three I mean
we have
um let's add the cell we have 13 out of
16 and this is correct
81.2 percent correct okay so that's it
uh we've gone from 79 percent to 83
percent by modifying or changing our
model now let's plot out as confusion
Matrix and see what we get
there we go your results which are much
better than what we have had so far
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and amazing section in which we are
going to treat the mobile net
architecture
this was first developed by Google
researchers in 2017 and we had the
mobile net version 1 and 2019 the again
developed the mobile net version 2 and
after this there was a mobile net
version three but yeah we are just gonna
focus on this mobile net version 2
entitled inverted residuals and linear
bottlenecks
by just looking at the title we could
guess the type of environments for which
this model was built for in fact the
mobile Nets have been built for
environments with low compare resources
like the mobile and Edge devices
so in this section we are going to focus
on what permits this model that's the
mobile net V2 to perform quite well in
terms of speed while producing high
quality results there are two major
techniques which make the mobile net
version 2 very powerful always permits
them
always permits us work at higher speeds
while still maintaining reasonable
quality results
now these two are the depth wide
separable convolutions
and the inverted residual bottleneck
which we have right here here's although
separable convolutions there's a regular
convolution your separable convolution
and we'll start by explaining what a
depth separable convolution is adaptable
convolution is simply a combination of a
depth wise convolution and a point-wise
convolution now this point-wise
convolution is nothing different from a
normal convolution layer but with Canon
size of one so one by one convolution
here that's a point-wise convolution and
before this we have the debtwise
convolution now to understand like this
now the depth uh separable convolution
which is uh this to uh put together in
sequence as or sequentially now to
understand what this depth wise uh
convolution is actually let's get back
to this demo where we saw how the usual
convolution operation works as you could
see here we have this input basically
let's let's have this uh let's talk
about the movement
so here we have some inputs now this
input is three-dimensional as you see
here we have one two three so zero one
two we have these three dimensions let's
change the color so it's clear for you
to see we have this First Dimension we
have the second dimension and then we
have this other
third dimension
now what goes on during the convolution
operation is that we have this uh kennel
so we have this year and then we have
also some kennel so in this case three
by three canal
uh we have this on a kennel here
three by three and the reason why it is
three by three is because we have three
channels here in the input so because
the inputs are three channeled all have
three channels we have a three Channel
kennel now here we could add this we
could add a foot channel right here add
this for channel and then we'll also
have here four of this kennels and then
what happens is going uh here during the
convolution operation is exactly what
we're seeing here so we have this one
which uh is placed at a given position
let's pick its color let's place at this
position for example and then we
multiply all the values like you can see
let's uh say we add this point here you
see at this point
we can see how this filter in this case
this filter so this filter is actually
we match this filter with this one we
match this one with this in red we match
this one uh with this in green uh now
since the three obviously we don't have
four now uh let's get back to this
operation where we take this one and
multiply with all the values we have
here so when we multiply all the values
we have here we get
for example in this case one by zero
plus zero times zero plus one times zero
you see all this at the top are canceled
and then we have zero times zero zero
times one cancel we have one times one
here so we have one and then we have one
then zero zero negative one times one
negative one so we have negative one and
then negative one times two we have
negative two so this gives us a value of
negative two
and then we move to the next one this
one let's change the color you see we
have one times uh all this at the top is
zero so when we multiply all this by
because it's just simply matching so
when we have one times zero we have zero
zero times zero zero one times zero zero
one times zero zero negative one times
two negative two
then negative 1 times 0 we have zero
negative one times zero zero negative
one times two negative two so this gives
us negative four
at this point we have negative four we
move to the next one
here we have negative four all this is
zero obviously so we just get to this
one one times one we have one uh zero or
negative one and then zero so we have
one let's write that we have one and uh
minus one
because this is negative one times one
minus one it gives us zero so here we
have negative six when you add all this
up basically we're taking this we
multiply and then we add here we take
this multiply we add take this multiply
we add and we add all these values and
this gives us your negative six now
because we have this bias of one we add
plus one it gives us negative five
that's how we obtain this value here
that's why we obtain this one right here
now
will repeat the same process
uh for all these filters all the
different positions so basically let's
toggle this so you see what happens you
see we repeat this process we move we
move we go down
and that's it
there we go so we repeat this to the end
and we have this final value right here
then if we want to have you see that we
get this so what we have is let's take
this off let's take this orange off what
we have is now we have this output so we
have the input which is
um the of the of Channel which has a
number of channels three here we also
have this number of channels three and
then we have an output which has number
of channels one but if we want the
number of channels to be equal say two
like in this case for the output we have
one channel and this other channel then
we need to increase the number of
filters we have here so basically here
we have how many filters we we we could
create this again so we will have now
two if we want to have output two then
we need to have two of this of this
three-dimensional filter so we will have
this again
would have this
with his own weights obviously and we
will have this and that's it so because
we have this two now
we will no longer have an output with
one channel but now an output with two
channels as you could see here now
notice how as we click this we move to
this next so this is this this year is
this one here let's pause this so this
year is this uh one right here
and this one
is this one right here now well with
this yeah we're able to get this other
channel for the output and so that's how
the convolution operation Works uh for a
normal convolution now if we get to the
depth wise convolution we'll find that
this uh a bit different from this uh
method for the deadwise convolution as
the name goes this computations are done
depth wise so first of all now here this
output
will only be gotten from interactions of
this channel
and this channel right here so what goes
on here is we take this and then we pass
it around as we usually do and then we
obtain
this new output right here so if this is
three by three then we'll obtain some
values uh one two three
four five six seven eight nine so those
values will be different from this one
because the way we compute these values
is different from the way these values
were computed the way we computed this
value was we take this year pass it here
take this pass this take this uh pass
this here and then add all our resulting
um sums to obtain this value of negative
five as we saw but in this case what
we'll obtain for this first value
wouldn't be this five what we'll obtain
here will be one times zero zero times
zero plus one times zero your zero zero
one times one we will have one and then
here we'll have zero your one times one
negative one uh negative two negative
one negative two gives us negative two
so what we'll obtain here will be
negative two
and then we'll move on to the next we'll
move on to the next we'll go to this uh
our next position we'll get some value
as we've seen here and up to this last
value right here so the way we got this
was we took all this in different uh for
different channels and then we added
them up to get this bigger we just get
this directly by taking for each and
every channel and just uh producing the
output like this so this means that with
this we are going to have like here
let's take this off with this because we
are having uh the each channel for the
filters producing its own output we're
gonna have this three producing three
different outputs so here already we
have three outputs unlike here where we
had two outputs and the two outputs here
were controlled by the number of candles
we used because here we use two canals
we have two outputs but here we this
doesn't matter your the number of output
or the number of input channels we have
here will dictate the number of outputs
so here we have three channels so we'll
just obviously have these three
different outputs now since we have
these three outputs and we want to be
able to control the number of output
channels what we'll do now after the
depthwise convolution which is in fact
what we've just explained here is we're
going to add now the one by one
convolution there's a point where it's
convolution after adding the one by one
convolution we are going to specify the
number of channels here and this number
of channels of this one by one
convolution that will permit us leave
from a certain number of channels like
in this case three to another number of
Channel or to a given number of channels
let's say two so after getting these
three channels or getting this apple
with three channels we now get we pass
through this point where it's
convolution and now we're gonna get just
two channels
to better understand this let's take
this their wise convolution image from
paper Suite code so here let's try to
reduce this anyway let's have this you
see we have uh one two three you see
this one two three this is a five by
five canal and then we pass this notice
how each and every one is now
responsible for its own output see this
you see we have this orange with this
void uh for this particular Channel
gives us an output the red gives us an
output the yellow gives us an output
unlike previously where we'll take this
past this year and then add all this
together
but now instead what we do is we just
simply carry out that addition at the
level of the channel and then we get
this output right here
now let's see why the that wise or the
separable convolution is more efficient
and we'll do this by calculating the
number of filters so here we find the
number of filters we need to get from uh
this input which is uh one two three
four five six seven so we have this
seven by seven
by three inputs which we want to convert
to this three by three by two output and
here the number of filters or number of
parameters we used can be calculated as
here we have uh nine times three
obviously in this nine times three comes
from the fact that we have for each of
this we have nine and times three the
three is from here actually because we
have three input channels then we will
have three uh filter channels and so
we're gonna have uh the photo size which
is three by three
I think we should change this color so
it makes it clearer let's change this so
here we have seven by seven by three the
threes for this number of channels here
we have three by three and then this is
three by three for a single one then
times three this number of Weights but
now because we want to have let's change
this color again here because we want to
have an output with two channels then we
would
multiply this again by the number of
output channels too so this like it's
some general formula to get the number
of parameters uh we're gonna omit the
biases so here we have three by three by
three between seven uh times two fifty
four parameters
now this means that if we have or if we
want to have number of channels of say
16 then this will give us
now let's consider that we're dealing
with uh depth wise uh convolution and
the point-wise convolution which would
form the depth separable convolution
with a Deb wise what would have
first of all we have to note that this
is no more uh needed we just need this
so what we have will be
um 3 by 3 by
3 now this three comes from the number
of inputs by now to get the number of
outputs
we wouldn't carry out any multiplication
here because uh basically the output
from the depth wise convolution is a
three by three
by three tensor in this case uh Mob or
we could just say is a three Channel
output since we have three Channel
inputs we have three Channel output so
here to obtain the outputs or we just
need this we saw this already we just
take this multiplier get the output get
this first one we take this multiplier
get this next one take this multiply
here get this next one and we're good to
go so once we have this we now add the
the weights for the point wise
convolution now for the point wise it's
uh one by one kennel so you see it's
quite cheap it's compared to the three
by three canals so one by one here we
have one by one so we let's just put
this here we have one by one
now times
the inputs just like with the with the
usual convolution is the same thing
actually because here for the for the
usual convolution here we have to
calculate number of Weights just get the
candle size uh then like one of the the
kind of size times the kind of size
times the number of input channels times
number of output channels so here we
have this kind of size times kind of
size times the number of input channels
which in this case is three
and the number of output channels which
is two
so that's what we have now if we
multiply this we have 27 plus 6 that
gives us uh something like uh 33 you see
that this is 33. now one interesting
point to note here is if we multiply if
we modify this and take and and say one
I have 16 Apple Channel then all changes
two and put 16 in that case our answer
will be 27 yeah we have 27
plus 48 now 27 plus 48 oh we get that
quickly uh five seven that gives us 75.
so you see that here we have uh
increased this number of channels from 2
to 16. number of weight 75 but when we
did that year number of Weights went to
432 so clearly the debt wise or the
depth separable convolution is one that
is way cheaper than the normal
convolution
and in the paper the others argue that
this uh kinds of convolution permits us
to reduce the computational cost by
eight to nine times then that of a
standard convolution while we have only
a small reduction in the accuracy
that said from this diagram here you
should Now understand why when
representing a regular convolution the
authors have this um
filter see the filter here which has
this um
depth into the input you see this depth
right here see this whereas when
representing the separable convolution
we have this filter which doesn't have
any depth
and that's because here we have no inter
Channel computation or calculations as
compared to this one and then after we
have this point wise now the point wise
is a regular convolution so we see we
have this depth gain but now it's uh
smaller in size because it's just a one
by one filter the next Improvement we
should look at is this inverted residual
block right here so it's first of all
called inverted in comparison to the
residual block now the residual block as
you may notice you have this uh large
relatively large Channel and then it
becomes small in the middle and then it
becomes large in the outputs so this
means that we have some inputs we have
some inputs and then we have our
residual block and then we have some
outputs then we have obviously this uh
link right here from the input to the
output now with this you see this
becomes the data other inputs big it
goes to small and then big but your what
we have is we pass in a relatively small
Channel small number of channels on
input with relatively smaller number of
channels so you're small and then in a
block it becomes the number of channels
increased and then as output number of
channels reduced hence the term inverted
uh residual block now in addition to the
fact that we're using depth wise
convolutions instead of the normal
convolutions
the fact that we have relatively lower
dimensional data getting into this block
and a lower dimensional data getting out
means that we could transport very low
dimensional data throughout our mobile
network so here we have low dimensional
data getting in low dimensional data
getting out and then inside we have this
expansion layer right here
as this expansion layer permits US
capture as much information as possible
from our input features one thing to
also note is the fact that we're using
the reload six the roller 6 is even from
a usual relu in the sense that with a
relu we have
for all X less than zero the value is
zero for all X greater than zero the
value is X so we have this Y equals X
line right here but with the relative 6
as from the value 6 we actually clip
this output so what we have here is all
values oh let's get back what we have
here is we have uh the values it remains
X but once we get to six it gets clipped
so for all values of X greater than six
the value remains at six so that's a
relative six and then one other
important point is the fact that because
we are doing or we're carrying out this
projection from high dimensional data to
low dimensional data this relu
non-linearity generally
will cause us to lose too much
information and because of that there is
no uh radioactivation in the final layer
here
you can see this in the summary right
here you see we have the inputs uh then
we have the expansion
factor which is T this means that now we
have this hyper parameter which we can
tune so if we want uh better results we
can change those expansion Factor so
that it permits us to get this better
results so here we have this expansion
Factor T here which uh expands number of
channels so we're getting with K and
then we we now move to TK and then we
have this
TK which now takes us to K Prime now
also note that here we have the relative
six relative 6 but here we have no
activation
now that said this is a summary of our
mobile net version 2. so here you have
mobile version two you have the
different model next there we go and
then we have
this conf2d average pool and then come
to D
this figure right here also shows us how
the mobile net version 2 outperforms the
mobile D1 Shuffle net and the nasnet you
see that uh with a mobile net version 2
right here uh if you pick this let's
pick for example this two you see the
number of
operations are the computation cost here
is almost similar but we see this great
difference in accuracy
where the mobile net V2 outperforms the
mobile net V1
then apart from classification the
mobile net V2 has been using other tasks
like object detection
um semantic segmentation
and other computer vision tasks where we
have low compute resource
hello everyone and welcome to the
session in which we treat this modern
convolutional neural network
architecture known as the efficient Nets
in this efficient net paper the authors
proposed a more controlled manner of
Designing convolutional neural networks
such that it suits our demands in
accuracy and speed
and as you can see in those plots you
see that we could choose suitable
parameters such that we could modify or
increase our accuracy while
taking note of how this affects the
speed that said in this section we'll
see how Ming Xing tang and Quark lay
built the system for automatically
scaling our convolutional neural
networks much more efficiently
confidence are commonly developed at a
fixed resource budget and then scaled up
for better accuracy if more resources
are available so with the case of the
resnet we had resnet 34 so your resnet
34 then after we had resnet 50 uh refnet
say 152
and depending on the kind of
um
setting we are gonna pick this uh resnet
model which will permit us to run
without
any problems of latency while
maintaining a reasonable accuracy so
this means that if we are working in a
high compute environment then we could
afford to work with this whereas if we
are working a low compute environment
then would have to work with this uh
model with fewer
conf layers
now that said in this paper the authors
propose a more systematic study of how
this model's scaling can be done
and unlike other methods where we just
killed by increasing the depth here the
proposal scaling by increasing the depth
increasing the width that's number of
channels and the resolution that is the
size of the input image
and so here the proposal new scaling
method that uniformly skills or
dimensions of that is that with
resolution using a simple yet highly
effective compound coefficient
you could see the results right here you
see for example the resonate 50 uh let's
extrapolate let's let's let's let's pick
this here although this has more
parameters on the rest at 50.
let's take inside the B4 because it has
less parameters so you see it has fewer
parameters than the rest net 50. Beth is
uh accuracy that's stop one accuracy on
the image net is much greater than that
of this resnet 50 year so we have the
efficient at B4 version which is about
83 percent uh that one percent accuracy
while this is only at about 76 percent
or one accuracy
now in this figure we see how we have
this Baseline some sort of Baseline like
in the case of the rest now we could say
this is resnet 18 and then we have uh
this deeper model depth scaling this
could be resnet say 50. now uh in this
case they have this Baseline first of
all this Baseline is gotten
by carrying out an automatic Network
architecture search so we we get this
Baseline and the different uh
layers we have for this Baseline and
then note that this Baseline has a a
depth as you can see we have it it has a
depth and when we scale deeper when we
we do we carry out depth scaling you see
we have much more layers added to this
one and then when we do with scaling we
increase the number of channels so you
see we have this smaller channels for
the Baseline and then the weed scaling
permits us to increase this number of
channels then also we have the
resolution scaling which has to do with
the inputs so there we have this input
height times width and now after current
resolution scaling we see we increase
this resolution this means that we may
work with a base of 224 by 224 and then
after scaling we may get to see
um 640 by 640.
then from here we also have the compound
scaling which is uh what is used in this
paper where we don't only focus on the
width or the depth or the resolution but
we scale all this systematically to
achieve the best possible results while
maintaining reasonable speeds
that said we could see from these
different plots that when you increase
like here we have a
the width that's the number of channels
which is increased you notice that as we
increase this number of channels at some
point it starts to plateau and then when
we increase the the depth at some point
to start to Plateau then when we also
increase this input size that's a
resolution at some point it starts to
plateau and so this is why the authors
propose a technique where we could
combine all this such that we get even
better results
and there we go we see the effect of uh
compound scaling you see that we have
this D depth and then our resolution you
see when the depth is one and resolution
is one we uh at this lower see we have
the worst results here whereas when we
double this depth and then our increase
relation resolution by 1.3 you see we
have this best results right here
that said we'll now dive a bit more
deeper and look at this compound
coefficient which they spoke of at the
very beginning so we go down here and we
have this formula right here see this
formula right here
all right on this equation which is
equation three where we have this depth
we have this different formulas these
three formulas the depth equal Alpha uh
times V and now those fees are user
specified coefficient that controls how
many more resources are available for
model scaling so this some sort of
scaling coefficient right here says V
Phi and then here we have alpha beta and
gamma now this is designed such that
Alpha Beta squared gamma squared is
approximately equal to and Alpha
algorithm equal one beta is always
greater than equal one and Gamma always
greater than equal one so now we are
going to carry out a grid search so
we're gonna search for the best uh
values for this alpha beta and gamma and
then fix them obviously you're they're
constant so we're going to fix this and
then now start varying fee such that we
carry out the scaling in a more
systematic manner
and there we go to carry out to or to
find the the values for alpha beta and
gamma the fixed fee to be equal one and
then they obtain Alpha 1.2 beta 1.1 and
Gamma 1.15 all of this search that we
have this constraint now oh they then
fix alpha beta and gamma as constants
and scale up the Baseline network with
the different files as we already
explained
and is based on those different values
of Phi that we obtain the different
versions of the efficient net going from
B1 to B7
now before moving on it's important to
take note of this efficient net b0 which
is our Baseline Network remember we have
some baseline Network which we have seen
here let's go this way we have this
Baseline Network right here this one
this Baseline Network which we're going
to scale
um such that we have better results
while
working with compute constraints
now that said let's scroll let's take
this off and then scroll down back to
this our Baseline model which is giving
just here in the stable you see we have
this Baseline model efficient net b0 and
then you'll notice first that the
resolution is 2 24 by 224 meaning that
we're going to start with image sizes of
224 by 224 but not that uh different
image sizes could be used for the
different uh models although the best or
the most adapted
resolution for each model should be
preferably used now that said here you
see we have a usual conf layer and then
we have this mbconf right here now
before getting to the mbconf also note
that after carrying out the neural
architecture search uh the authors
notice that we could also make use of
those five by five candle or five by
five candle size filters so unlike what
we have discussed in previous sessions
this 5x5 Canal size filters are still
very useful then get into the MB conf we
find here
here they say it's main building block
it's is this mobile inverted bottleneck
so we call the mobile inverter
bottleneck which we found in sunlight
all sunlight all is the mobile net
version two people we have seen already
to which they also add the squeeze and
excitation optimization now in the
mobile net version 3 The Squeeze and
excitation optimization was added so
here we have basically or the mobile net
inverted
residual block which we have seen
already and then if we check out this
mobile net V3 paper which you can feel
free to look at
you would have this squeeze and
excitation right here let's zoom into
this see here we have the mobile net
version 2 with bottleneck with residual
uh this residual then our bottleneck as
usual here we have this low Dimension
input getting in and then it gets
expanded and then we have this uh low
Dimension output which is produced in
this final layer right here now with
this
um squeezing excitation to better
understand those squeezing excitation uh
layer we should or we could get back to
how the conf layers actually work you
see that to get this outputs let's take
this off to get this output for example
We Carry Out multiplications and
additions for each and every channel
you're that's for each and every channel
on the input and those filters which
correspond to this Channel and then to
produce this negative one right here
others are added up with equal weights
so the output from this computation
let's call it Alpha will be put here
plus the output from this computation
let's call it beta we will put here plus
the output from this computation let's
call it gamma will be put here and we'll
get this value or this output of
negative one at this position now what
does quiz and excitation layer brings in
is
some weights on this uh addition
operation right here so instead of just
having a weight of one year one and year
one we're gonna have some modified
parameters or some parameters added here
such that
certain channels influence the outputs
more than some others
and so here we could have instead of one
we have a width a or after with b and
your await C
getting back to his paper the way this
is done is uh as such we start by
carrying out some pulling and the result
of this pulling will be one by one by C
output now C is the number of channels
so if you're we have C channels here we
have this I'll put your C so this up
here will be one by one by C just you
notice how this is small and then we
have C the size the size C is exactly
the same size right here
so we have exactly this size is the same
as this
and then for the height and width is one
by one
now once we get this
we pass this through two fully connected
layers you see with this relative
activation and then here we have this
hard sigmoid
activation after this fully connected
layer and then here we get this output
of this same
number of channels C
which will match with this one
but now what we get here will be
multiplied by uh each and every channel
here so this now we serve as the weights
will serve as because remember we we
designed this as a
a alpha
plus meter
plus gamma and then we had a b and then
C so this a b and c is actually this uh
output right here we're supposing that c
the the other channel size equal three
so we have this three here and there's
these are the values which we get after
going through this fully connected layer
and then we take this now and multiply
by each and every channel so if you
break this up into three parts let's
let's remove this
oh there is this and we could cut this
let's cut this into three parts so we
have one two three so we suppose that's
one by one by three so if we have this
this first path we'll multiply
this chunk so we'll multiply this chunk
and then this Auto Part will multiply
this next chunk and then this other part
here will multiply this other chunk and
so now we have this
um channels whose
contribution to this output is now
weighted
that said we also have the expansion
Factor there is six
then getting back to the results we see
how the efficient Nets perform better
than the corresponding or
other confidence with similar number of
parameters or even more number of
parameters like here we see how the
efficient net b0
outperforms the resonant 50 though you
see this great difference number of
parameters
as the efficient net is more efficient
as or has fewer parameters as compared
to the resnet 50. we see resonant
efficient at B1 compared to resnet 152
you see 60 million you're 7.8 but this
one is more accurate than the resnet
152.
um you could check out from this right
up to efficient net B7 you see we have
this g-pipe
um they are 97 97 but this one has 557
million parameters while this is only at
66 million parameters
and we could also look at the floating
Point operations you see here uh we have
fewer floating Point operations
for the efficient at b0 while still
having higher accuracy
we also see that if we scale the mobile
Nets and the rest Nets will still they
wouldn't still get better results
compared to the efficient net
and it shows the power of the network
architecture search which was used in
getting our Baseline now we'll go down
and check out this year we have
um this results right here you see the
the Class Activation map which is a
visualization technique which permits
practitioners understand how the model
or rather what portions of the inputs
helped in producing
the outputs shows clearly here that when
we use compound scaling
we have the map which is more focused on
relevant regions as you could see right
here as compared to the Baseline model
and this other
models with the zipper with depth
scaling with scaling and resolution
scaling
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
going to treat transport learning and
fine-tuning transfer learning can be
applied in several domains like computer
vision natural language processing and
speech in order to better understand the
usefulness of transfer learning we have
to take note that deep learning models
work best when given much data and so
this means that if you have a data set
of only a hundred data points then
you're most likely going to have a
poorly performing model but what if we
tell you that it's possible to train
your model or to train a given model on
say a million data points and then use
that model or adapt that model such that
you can now train it on this your very
small data set such that you start
getting very great results this is very
possible with transfer learning and
that's why I wish I'll be treating in
this section at this point one question
which may be going to your minus how is
it possible to train a model
made of say a million daily points and
then use that same model on a smaller
data set which is obviously different
from this data set
with about 100 data points
the answer to this question lies in this
figure we have right here
notice how you have this image here this
image of this truck
and then we have this model which takes
this input and then produces some
outputs right here
this model or the kind of model we'll
use for this image tasks are generally
the conf Nets as we've seen already in
this course and with the curved Nets we
generally have two main sections the
first section is the feature extractor
and then as we go towards those final
sections here we have the classifier
and so the very first thing the conf net
we want to do will be to extract low
level features and then as we go towards
the end we start uh or we focus on
extracting more high level features
notice how your uh with this let's pick
out this uh feature right here
all this feature map you see that we
pick up these edges you see for other
feature Maps we actually filtering out
some low level features or extracting
those low level features from our input
then as we go get towards the end we get
more high level features
like for example whole portions of the
image like the tire
and then after this we generally have a
classifier which now permits us to pick
between a set of options which one the
model thinks this image is actually
now because the confnet works this way
it means that if we have two data sets
which are similar
then we could build some sort of feature
extractor or we could build a model
which will extract features from this
very large data set and then
because this weights have been tuned or
have been trained such that the extract
features correctly then when we pass in
this very small data set this section of
the model will do just its job that is
of extracting useful features from this
data set
and you see that because these two data
sets are similar it's going to do a
great job and so we will not need
a very large data set in order to
extract features from this uh small 100
size data set right here
and so in fact what we're saying is we
have a model let's say we have this
model then we have this feature
extractor unit and then we have this
classifier units which we've seen
already
generally this starts after the
flattening or the global average pooling
and then here we have some dense layers
while with this we have a confnet or
some convolutional layers with some Max
pool and batch Norm layers so what we'll
say now is we have this our small data
set which we're going to pass in here
and then we'll get at this point so it's
here that we're gonna get this
outputs from our
feature extractor unit
and then since generally we have for
example or we pre-train this model
note the word pre-trained because we are
somehow using this for the first time in
this course we are pre-training or we
pre-trained free that's we did the
training before we pre-trained the model
on a large or relatively large data set
like for example imagenet let's let's
suppose that we train on some larger set
with 1 billion images then this uh unit
year has lent to extract features from
whatever image you give it and so now
when you come with just a hundred images
what it does is it extracts those
features and then since in the at the
level of this classifier we have a
different setup for the pre-training we
now have to modify this classifier so
this means that uh if before let's
suppose that let's suppose that before
we had after the global pulling we have
um say oh 100 unit dense layer and then
1000 output dense layer right here then
in our case where we have just three
outputs what we'll do now is we'll
simply replace this here we'll take all
this off and then now we may pass this
say directly to the to the three output
dense layer or we may pass this first to
say uh 128 and then to this three output
dense layer so from here we see that
this new model will focus more on the
classification while allowing the
previous pre-trained model to take care
of extracting this features from uh
bitter
now it should be noted that we generally
use this concept of transfer learning
when we have a very small data set and
obviously since deep learning models
perform best with larger set we want to
get the best out of them and so we want
to use the transfer learning when we
have a small data set as we've said and
we
have this model which has been
pre-trained to extract this useful
features from the those kinds of images
so the simply means that we should have
two
similar data sets another advantage of
using or where can we transfer learning
is that you get to gain
in terms of training compute cost that
is this model which was pre-trained may
have been trained for say three days and
then now all you need to do is just get
the screen model and then apply transfer
learning on your own specific and
smaller task
and so when you're running on limited
budget you find that working with
pre-trained models is
going to be really helpful
now apart from transfer learning we also
have fine tuning which is quite similar
in the sense that
unlike with the transfer learning where
we have this year that's this feature
extractors weights which are fixed
and then during training we update the
weights of this classification section
with fine tuning what we could do is
also update the weights of this feature
extractor section now generally we start
fine-tuning from the top so we suppose
that this is the bottom here so we have
the input and then we have this final
layer so we would say that we start
finding it from this final layers going
to this uh initial layers so here we
have this fine tuning process we could
get this first this top layers that is
we fix this layers here we keep these
layers fixed so their weights aren't
updated during the training process and
then we update this weights while
obviously we updated this we updated
this ways already but the difference is
that this weights were initialized from
scratch that is we randomly initialize
this weight whereas this weights are
initialized
from the pre-trained model
now this once this Waits here from the
pre-trained model but they are not
trained now uh we could again depending
on the kind of results we're getting
meaning that if we apply fine tuning to
the stop layers or to this final layers
and we get better results you see that
what we could do is we could keep fine
tuning so we could keep increasing this
or this section of
um ways we could update in the feature
extractor unit so here we'll take this
off take this off and now we have this
part which we can train so this is
trainable this is untrainable or not
trained so you have something like this
now it's also possible for us to go
ahead and just say okay we're gonna
train all our model but while carrying
out fine-tuning if there's one thing you
need to note is that
you have to use a very small learning
rate and the reason why you're doing
this is to avoid
disrupting this weight values which have
taken very much time to attain
and so as we do the fine tuning we're
going to update this weights but very
slowly
and by the getting this by updating this
weight very slowly we mean we're gonna
choose a very small learning rate
and then observe how this affects our
model's performance at this point we'll
get straight to the code and we'll look
at some pre-trained models so here you
could see you get into this tensorflow
applications you have called Next model
the internet model efficient model
efficient V2 we've seen the efficient
already Inception net mobile net which
we've seen mobile net V2 V3 and as net
and the famous res Nets which we've seen
already with the vggs and the exception
net so here you have the choice of
speaking out any one of this we're gonna
go straight to the efficient net so we
could have this here or you could get or
you could pick the efficient at V2 so
could pick any one of this so here we're
gonna pick the efficient net B4 this one
since he has slightly fewer number of
parameters compared to the resnet 50 and
it outperforms the resident 50 by very
large margin so we're gonna pick this
efficient D4
and if there's one thing you can do with
tensorflow is simply the fact that you
could use these models without having to
code them out from scratch so as you can
see here we have this tensorflow caress
applications efficient net everything
that before and then we just have this
argument with this we get oh we're going
to Define our efficient model we paste
this right here and we'll call this the
back bone so we've seen this already now
here we're not going to include the top
recall that as we had seen here we have
this
um
or model and then let's take this fine
tuning pad off we have this whole model
and then what we are interested is in
this feature extractor unit so we'll set
that include top to false let's get back
here we have include top we're not going
to include this we set this to false
stick this off and then the weights have
been pre-trained on the imagenet data
set uh we're going to take this input
tensor we have the input shape now this
input shape will have a configuration so
basically we have configuration the
image size
the IM size
there we go in size by configuration
and since we are not including the top
as we've said here we're not going to
take into consideration this classes now
the classifier activation so we have
that off and then oh we could decide
whether to include the pulling layer or
not and if we want to pick the pulling
layer then we'll have to specify what
pull and layer we want to work with
either the average or the max so with
this we are just going to take this off
and specify that uh later on so here we
have our backbone we run the cell and
then what we do to freeze what we call
this is freezing so what we do to freeze
this backbone such that the weights
aren't updated during training is by
simply setting this here to to false or
setting this trainable
parameter to false to
backbone.trainable equal false and
that's it so this all we need to do to
freeze our model now Frozen our model
the next thing to do is to add this
other layer right here all these other
layers so we'll go straight away
then here we're going to Define this
input with the image size
now once we have this input we now pass
in or we have the backbone so we have
the backbone here which has been defined
and uh parameters have been set to be
Frozen and then from here we have the
global average pulling so we have global
average pulling here then we now have
this dense layer now the configurations
we'll set this number of dense layer 1
to
1024 and number of dense layers 2 to 128
so let's get back to this there we go uh
we have that and then from here we're
gonna have batch normalization layer
uh there we go let's copy this paste it
out here we have another dance layer now
this time around second one that's fine
and then finally we have this dense
layer activation soft Max so here we
have our soft Max activation and then
this is number of classes
here we have number of classes and
that's fine so let's take this off now
and then run this
cell right here
we get in this Arrow because we have to
specify this this way that's fine and
that's it so now we have this model you
see total parameters 19 million the
trainable parameters just 1.9 million
and the non-trainable parameters are
17.6 million so it means that the
backbone itself is 17.6 million and then
this additional parameters here come
with a remaining 1.9 million parameters
now with this we have our model already
set you see with minimal code and we
could go ahead to start the training
then you're gonna start by training our
model again we compile the model and we
run the training process
now training is over we could go ahead
and evaluate our model so let's run this
and what do we get we have close to 85
percent accuracy and
95.3 percent top K accuracy
and this does slightly better than the
previous models which we had worked with
let's go ahead and test this so it
changes to model and we run this here
um incompatible found shape this
we're gonna resize this before passing
into the model so here we have this
image and just here we have Let's see we
have our test image which will resize so
we'll use
um opencv to resize this image we pass
in our test image and then we specify
this
um item size
so here we have in size copy this
and there we go let's run this again
and here's what we get see we have the
sad output now let's go ahead and check
this out here
we run this
here we have one miss
um Miss no miss the second miss here we
have two misses
and that's it so out of the 16 we have
um two misses that is 14 divide that by
16.
um about 87.5
accuracy on this small or batch of
images which we took from the validation
data set
we'll go ahead and check out the
confusion metrics oops let's run this
run this
let's get back
and here's how confusion metrics we get
even better results
but one thing we have to note here is
that our data set was not that small and
so we may not
um see this change or this difference
between training from scratch and uh
using transfer learning so what we'll do
is we will take this we'll take just say
10 that's 320 so would have a little set
of 320 data points and then we'll see
the difference when we train from
scratch and when we train with
a pre-trained model
so right here let's get back to this we
take this down and we're gonna use we
could use any of this one so let's let's
pick the lunette's quite simple pick the
net and then your we have
um and this let's scroll down we have
training
loss function the same Matrix the same
and here we have lunette's model so run
that and yeah the net model
that's fine
and so here we train on this small part
and validate on the full validation data
set we'll do this for just 28 books
so after training for training eBooks on
that very small data set you see the
model doesn't perform well you see it
doesn't even get up to 50 percent
validation accuracy while the train
accuracy keeps increasing so the model
is overfitting now uh from here we are
now going to change this so we're going
to use our model this pre-trained model
so we have this here we just run this
again so we initialize this parameters
and then we'll compile the model uh this
is model so let's let's call this
pre-trained pre-trained model let's
change this name here
pre-trained model
there we go we have uh
pre-trained model and we get the
pre-trained model summary
that's fine
um yeah we have that and then here we
have pre-trained
pre-trained model okay so yeah we're
gonna run this pre-trained model compile
and then we'll start with the training
again
so just note that we we had the accuracy
validation accuracy below 50 percent
previously and now we're gonna check out
our validation accuracy when working
with the pre-trained model but already
one thing you could notice just after
two ebooks like here see after these two
ebooks we're gonna see this validation
accuracy which is already greater than
50 even from the first ebook it was
already greater than 50 it shows you the
power of working with pre-trained models
as we are now making use of those
extracted features to get this much more
performing model see the accuracy keeps
increasing
now we're done with the training you
could see that this model which before
we couldn't cross this uh 50 Mark for
the validation accuracy now is able to
cross the smack as we'll see here you
see we have the validation accurate of
71 percent while just training on 320
data points so let's get here let's run
this and you could see what we have here
you see it gets uh just above 70 percent
so now with pre-training we get above 70
percent
and we even got greater than 50 percent
just from the very first ebook
and so what we could see from here is
the very first thing is get as much
cleaned data as possible and if you
can't lay hands on this uh try some did
augmentation and then from here if your
data set is still very small then you
could then apply transfer learning
but if you have a relatively large data
set uh it will be needless applying
transfer learning as training from
scratch
should normally get you better results
so here we could evaluate our model so
you could see that that's our pre
pre-trained model
we just 10 out of 213 batches which
produces
71.3 percent validation accuracy
we now move on to fine-tuning as we've
looked at transfer learning and now we
get into fine tuning uh but before
getting to fine-tuning would we would
first convert this R code which was
built with the sequential
API now into the functional API so
here's our converted model it's
basically the same thing we have the
input we have the backbone which takes
in this input produces output global
average pulling dance layer batch Norm
dance layer and this dance layer right
here then we have our fine-tuned model
right here let's run this code cell and
then we could view a summary which is
meant to be identical to what we had
already with the pre-trained model so
yeah we we have this 17.673
uh thousand see this is six seven five
it doesn't match with what we expect so
let's get back here and we'll notice
that we did not put this here so let's
um X would not include a batch Norm
layer so let's run this again and then
we now have this summary right yeah
which is exactly the same as that of our
previously built model with a sequential
API
and then now we want to fine tune our
model that is all these layers which
were frozen that is not trained we now
want to make them trainable
so right here we'll get back and then we
simply have backbone dot trainable and
we set that to true
then here we are gonna set this
trainable
to false now recall when we're building
this resnet34 model right here we have
this trainable parameter which we made
use of you remember here we had
training sorry it's not trainable let's
get back here that was training so we
should have training here now trainable
is different from this one so take note
of that this is trainable and this is
training so when we set this training to
false
and uh we'll get back here you'll find
that this batch Norm took in this
training parameter and the reason why we
need this especially for the batch Norm
is simply because
the batch Norm Works differently during
training and in France
and then doing training the barge Norm
layer normalizes its output using the
mean and the standard deviation of the
current batch of inputs
whereas doing inference
the batch Norm layer normalizes its
outputs using a moving average of the
mean and the standard deviation of the
batches it has seen during the training
so
since at inference or when we
fine-tuning we do not want the batch
Norm to take the current
mean or rather the mean and the standard
deviation from the current batch of
inputs
we are instead going to compute this
from what it saw during training
and so that's why this training
parameter is very important we have this
um training right here see it takes the
input and the training
where we could set training to be false
for training mode and training to be
it's rather trained to be true for
training mode and trying to be false for
inference or let's say
fine tuning now before we move on you
should note that this layer the
trainable is set to false is different
from setting training to false when you
set a layers trainable parameter to
false
it simply means we do not want to update
the weights when training but when we
set training to false it means we're
working in inference mode
in the case of the batch Norm this gamma
and beader are trainable parameters and
so when we say
um layout alternate body called false it
means that they are not going to be
updated during training
but on the other hand this mean and
variance
aren't trainable parameters instead
there are parameters which adapt to the
training data
and that is why when we add inference
mode that's when we set training to
false we do not want to disrupt
the mean and variance values gotten
during the training are based on the
training inputs
and so
as we saw already this
mean and variance at inference mode will
be simply the moving average of the mean
and standard deviation of the batches it
has seen during training
and so clearly this two concepts the
that's set in the weights to parameters
not to be trainable and so clearly the
concept of setting this weights
not to be trainable is different from
that of working in inference mode
nonetheless it should be noted that
um in the case of the batch Norm set in
trainable to false on the layer means
that the layer will be subsequently run
in inference mode
now although we've seen that there's two
aren't they don't mean actually the same
thing now also note here that setting
trainable on a Model containing other
layers will recursively set the
trainable value of all inner layers and
if the value of the trainable attribute
is changed after calling compile method
on a Model the new value doesn't take
effect for this model onto compile is
called again
okay so that's it you could check out
all the drop out here we have this drop
out
um layer
which doesn't have any trainable
parameters but remember that the way the
Dropout works is that you have let's say
some inputs let's take this off you have
some inputs
and then if you to pass through the
Dropout layer
um at the end you have some of these
inputs which will be not considered so
you have maybe this would proceed with
this not take into consideration maybe
this moves and then this not taken to
consideration so the drop out
um of 0.5 simply means that half of our
inputs will be will move forward and the
other half will not be taken into
consideration and so you see that
at inference that is when we are
actually trying to test our model we do
not need to drop out some of this um
neurons right here and so generally
the Dropout also takes in this training
parameter here where when we set
training to true it means that we are in
training mode and so we could actually
drop out some of this values whereas
when we set the training to false then
we are in inference mode and so we do
nothing so we just allow the inputs to
pass without any modifications
and you could also see clearly from here
that the layer
dot trainable doesn't really apply
because
um drop out doesn't have trainable
parameters whereas we'll with
this training We could decide whether
it's true or false that is what in
straining mode or
um inference mode
so in fact what we're saying is we have
this model here
so in fact what we're seeing is we have
this model here we have the backbone and
we have the head for classification uh
we apply transfer learning by freezing
all this we freeze all our backbone so
no no parameter here is updated during
training and then now we move on to
fine-tuning where in fine tuning we want
uh to update these parameters with a
very small learning rate and then we
also want to avoid a situation where
those
mean and variant statistics which we
have gotten during the training process
will be
upsetted during this fine-tuning process
and so the batch Norm is kind of like a
special layer where
even during the fine tuning where we
want or where we have set the trainable
to to true that is we want to update
this weights during the training we do
not want to modify
or offset the batch norms
mean and variance and so we are going to
set this training year
false
so it still behaves as if it were in
inference mode
so getting back here we have our
training which has been set to false and
then we could start
um training our model again but one
point to note here is
we do the fine tuning on a pre-trained
model which has already been trained so
what we'll do is we're not going to
start training this model this way we'll
start by training the pre-trained model
so we start by having this backbone to
be set to false and this training is set
to false
so we're going to repeat the transfer
learning process again before then
applying fine tuning so each time you
want to apply fine tuning make sure you
have this set to false training set to
false and then you go ahead so yeah
let's run this again uh here's our fine
tune model
which achieves uh best validation
accuracy of about 70 percent okay now
we're done with transfer learning we're
not going to apply fine tuning to do
this we're going to set this to true so
all we need to do is set this to True
We're Not Gonna rerun this again we is
the same model and that's even the idea
the idea is for us to start with the
backbone which is not trainable and then
later on make it trainable
oh wow now just simply
recompile the model so don't forget to
recompile this model to take into
consideration the fact that some parts
of the model are now trainable so let's
get back here recompile the model and
see what this gives us
now as we start training we noticed that
this validation accuracy here isn't
um
looking like what we expect because
before getting to the fine tuning we
already had a model with the validation
accuracy of about 70 percent but now
we're getting this 33 and the simple
reason why this is so is because our
learning rate here we still maintain the
same learning rate instead of reducing
it before the fine tune it so we'll have
to stop this
here then would get back to this year
set this to false
so would have to start by the whole
process set this to false
and then we retrain the model we get
this accuracy of about 70 percent now we
get back here and we set this to true so
we set this to true that's fine we run
the cell backbone now trainable and then
we are going to make sure this Landing
right here we divided by a hundred so
we're going to make use a very small
learning rate now uh once we have this
we're gonna run this again so we're
gonna compile our model and restart the
training process training are completed
the other results we get you could see
that the validation accuracy increases
up to
um
72.2 percent so we make an extra gain of
two percent for the validation accuracy
after fine-tuning our model and this
makes sense since fine-tuning very meets
us to squeeze out
some extra juice from this backbone
since this time around it's actually
trainable
and that said we've just completed a
section on transfer learning
thanks for getting around to this point
and see you in the next section
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we're
gonna visualize the convolutional neural
networks feature Maps one very important
part of building robust deep learning
models involves understanding how those
models work or understanding what goes
on in the different hidden layers and so
in the section we'll focus on taking a
model which has already been pre-trained
and then generating this feature Maps so
we get to see exactly what goes on under
the hood the pre-trained model we'll be
using here will be the vgg 16 so we'll
simply copy this get back to our code
paste this out
um there we go we have our vgg 16 we are
going to take the top so we'll take all
this off now our input shape and we'll
take this input tensor off we're not
going to include the top so we set this
to false that's it then this input shape
will Define it as a m size here so we
have of configuration
M size that's fine
and we add this here okay so that's it
we set this and we give it this name vgg
backbone so we have VG backbone right
here
we can check out the summary vgg
backbone
summary
run that
there we go
you see it has about
14.7 million parameters
we now move on to the next step where
we're going to create this other model
which will permit us visualize this
feature Maps now to explain how this
works let's recall that we have this vgg
right here so we have our vgg and then
what the vgg does is it takes in an
input image so we have an input image
and then it produces a single output now
if we have say
um
not included at top then we would have
this app which is eight by eight by
512. so here we have
um eight by eight by five hundred and
twelve
and when it took in this 256 by 256 by 3
input
now since we have only this one single
output
and we are interested in visualizing the
hidden layers that what go that's what
goes in the vgg model what we'll do now
is we'll create a new model we'll create
a new model right here which instead now
has many different outputs and there's
different outputs will come from this
different hidden layers so we could take
this one and it becomes now an output
this one it becomes an output this one
output and so on and so forth so
basically this hidden layers now are
this hidden or the outputs of the Hidden
layers that's our feature Maps will
become our outputs so we'll now have
this model with this as input and then
this as outputs so this will be now our
different outputs instead of just a
single output now we have this different
outputs still be about 17 outputs in
total now you may also decide to pick
the specific output so you may want to
take only the conf layers or only the
outputs of the conf layer so you omit
the max pool layers uh your your year
and year with this one but it all
depends on you and we'll see how to do
this so let's get back to the code well
we're not going to build our future Maps
so we'll take the future maps and then
we'll put this in a list so here we'll
get the layer output and this for layer
in
the vgg backbone layers so we we have
this vgg backbone layers right here
all this vgg backbone model here we're
gonna get all its layers starting from
this one we're not going to pick the
input so we'll simply have this
and that will be it so we take this
layers and then from here
we'll build this new model which we'll
call feature
map model
and Securus model from here it takes in
as inputs the vgg backbone
so we have vgg backbone
input here we have the VG backbone input
to the same input but now what the
difference is that the outputs is this
feature Maps here so we don't have this
just one output but all this other
um
hidden layer outputs will now become our
outputs are we part of our outputs so
here we have feature Maps so that's it
we've built this new model we'll uh view
the summary feature map model dot
summary
and now we go so that's it uh it will
look similar to what we have but if we
had picked say from model 1 to just
model four or sorry from layer one to
layer four then you see it's shutting
because this all we need for this our
new model but since we're getting right
up to the end you see that we actually
go through the whole vgg model but the
difference that now uh we have outputs
that we have many outputs uh and we have
just this one single input
unlike before where we have one input
and one output so from here we have this
uh model which we've just uh this new
model which we've just designed starts
from one
run that again you have that and now
let's head on to
pass in an input through this model so
what we want to do now is we take this
input image and then we pass it into our
model and now since our model outputs
the different feature Maps the different
hidden uh layer outputs we will now be
able to visualize what's going on inside
our vgg model
now to get this output we are going to
use something similar to the testing
which we've seen already recall we did
we carry out this testing here where we
take we read this image we could simply
copy this where we read this image and
then we pass it to our model to get the
output but now in our case the model
let's reduce this the model we'll be
working with is a newly created feature
map model
so let's have this here
and that's it we have our test image we
resize we pass this in
this feature map model and then you'll
see that
when we run this we now check out
feature Maps so we'll say for let's say
for I in range length of the feature
Maps we want to print out
want to print out the fmap ship so we
have that
list has no attribute shape oh okay F
Maps I so let's pick out this I we run
that and it's and you see this so you
see that the output starts from here
from this uh one instead of the input
starts from it actually starts from here
as we since we have decided to start
from this one since we start from here
because we don't want to include the
input as part of our output so that's
logical we have that we start from this
right up to this very last one year
now here we've picked the conf layers
and the max pool layers so we have all
this now so we can now
visualize this different feature Maps
right here
now let's note this length let's print
this out let's note this length you see
we have 18 different outputs we get back
here and we modify this so we'll say
that we'll only do this if is conf of
layer
dot name is true so if this is true if
this is true then we are going to attach
this to the outputs now uh we could also
do this we could just simply have it
like this and that's fine now so what
this means is we are only going to take
the conf layers as part of our output
now we could Define this is conf
Discount takes in a layer name so
basically this layer names uh what we
have here does you see why it's
important to always give your layers
some names because now you see it's
helpful always it's used now to
differentiate between the different
um types of uh layers so here we have
this layer name and then we're gonna say
that if this layer name in this layer
name
or rather if
conf
in the layer name
we return true
then else
we return
false so we run that
we go we run this again it looks similar
to what we had before but one thing
you'll notice now is that this length is
reduced so we've taken off five we've
gone from 18 to 13. so we've taken off
five layers which correspond to this Max
pool layers since this conf uh this conf
isn't in this name right here so that's
it we have that we could also decide to
say okay we want to take only the max
pools so we will say if pull
oh pull we run that and we check this
line you see now only five there we go
so that's it oh let's get back to conf
and we have that okay so now we've run
this and we have the different ships now
to carry out the final visualization you
see you have this F Maps here so we're
gonna go through each and every feature
map so for I in range the length of uh
feature Maps
we now create this figure
and then we specify the fixed size so we
have fixed size equal to 56 by 256. now
we have that
we call this method right here and then
from here since we're going through each
and every feature map it's important for
us to get the feature size so we want to
get this values for each feature map now
with this we just simply have fmaps we
have K and then our router I here so we
get in this we pick a feature map we get
that and then we get the shape
uh one so this will permit us to get
this value since this is shape 0 ship
one ship two ship three so we get this
feature size the feature Map size then
we now get to those number of channels
so we have n channels
equal the feature Maps I shape three
three because the zero one two three so
this is how we get number of channels
now we have this already set
we want to be able to visualize this
such that like you're such that all
these channels are aligned on a single
line so because we have this
512 16 by 16. let's let's check this
area once we have like here we have 64
256 by 256 images so let's suppose that
this is one of them yeah we have this
256 by 256 right here
and then we have 64 of this for the 64
different channels
right here now what we want to do is
take this one let's take this one
put it here take this other one and
align it
take the next one align it so we could
visualize this in one line up to the
very last one right here
so to do this now what we'll do is we'll
create another
array which we'll call joint Maps
joint Maps
uh mp1 to initialize that way and then
the size yours we take the feature size
so we have F size and then to get the
this for the width this for the height
actually so we we know that the height
in the case of 256 by 256 this height is
256. so we have this height to 56 this
distance to 56 but then now the width is
going to change so the width is no
longer 256 by 256 times in this case 64.
so here we have
um 256 here we have F size times the
number of channels so that's how we do
that so with that we now have this joint
Maps which is angelized to one so we
have this uh array Now set now the next
step will be to fill in this values this
outputs this features in this R array
now we understand how this giant Maps
here was created we now go ahead to fill
this um information of this different uh
features in those giant Maps array so
yeah we'll do we'll go through the
different channels so for J in uh range
uh and channels so basically in channels
we have that
and then we fill in the joint Maps now
the way we'll do this is we'll keep the
height fixed so we have the height fixed
and then in this width dimension would
fill this information in a way that
as we go from one channel to another we
are going to skip steps of 256. so here
we will have
um f size or filter size our feature uh
Map size is 256 F size times J and then
we go to F size times
J plus 1. so what this means is would we
fix the height as we've said already we
will fix this height here the height is
fixed 256 that's it here so we'll take
all
um elements in the height and then for
the width
When J equals zero for example we have 0
up to
zero plus one so here we have zero zero
plus one so we have zero
and then zero times F size is zero then
one times F size is
256. so this means that in the width
dimension we're gonna go in the height
we have 256 and the width we have 256.
now when J goes to 1 now here we have
one one times F size is 256 so we have
256 and then 1 plus 1 is 2 2 times 256
is 512. so now we'll skip 256 steps at
this point we're at this point now and
we get this one and then we repeat this
same process again when when J equals 2
we have 512 and then we move to this
should be 768.
um no 2 5 6
yeah 768. so now we go from 512 to
768. and so that's how we're going to be
filling up this different positions
right here
now once we have this already set we now
go ahead and pass in the data what we
have to fill in here so we have F maps
and then we take in I if we consider
this case where J equals zero that's
we've picked this Zone from 0 to 256 and
we've collected all the height then we
have this patch right here and to fill
up this patch we have our feature Maps
uh which we've seen already but then we
are going to take a particular feature
map obviously this I here picks that
particular feature map then once we pick
the particular feature map we can now go
ahead and set this here to the values of
the feature Maps while selecting the
particular Channel
so now we when J equals zero for example
we take the zero Channel and so we'll
take all the values which come before
and then pick out now this zero channel
for example now here's G so that's it
we'll have we have our join Maps which
has now been created and then we could
take this off
are we now ready to plot our image so we
have this in show and then we pass
engine Maps now if we want to pass all
this it's going to be very
um
Ram consuming so we'll just take the
select all the Heights and then we'll
pick some value so go from zero to for
example
512. so we'll have that and now we could
run this but before running this we need
to set the different axes here we have
axis
then we have plot that subplot
uh the length of the feature Maps so
here we'll basically if we have 13
feature Maps then we're gonna have this
um different subplots yeah one and then
yeah we have I plus one so that's it so
once we have this set we can now run
this and see what we get takes a while
to run
and now that's complete we could
visualize the results here
let's simply scroll down and you see
this result you see for the initial
layers we have this low level features
which have been extracted so we have you
could see this clearly here and as we go
down or as we go further or deeper into
the network this uh the features we
extracting start to become more high
level features so you see this
see here see this one
um focuses see here we extract this
mouth here
unlike before where we're more focused
on
um edges
so that's it we keep going deeper and we
see the outputs or the results we're
getting
and that's it we've just visualized a
trained models feature Maps
now another thing we could do is suppose
at this beginning year that we have none
right here so we don't we we don't want
the pre-trained weights so we run this
run this again and check out on what we
are gonna or what the model is going to
produce
here's what we get you let's scroll so
you get to see this you see the inputs
um and as we go deeper
we'll notice that
not much information is yet to be
extracted from the inputs
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
gonna see how to implement the grad cam
technique which permits us visually
explain how the Deep neural networks
work this was first developed in this
paper by Ram prasadi all and entitled
Grant cam a visual explanations from
Deep networks via gradient based
localization so as you could see here we
have this input for example let's reduce
this we have this original image and
then we could see this grad cam output
now the task here as a classification
task where we're trying to see whether
there's a cut or darken the image and
then with the grad cam for the cats we
are able to detect the portion of the
image which influenced the model to say
that there's a cat in the image and also
for the grad cam dog we have this part
here which shows us that this portion
influences the model the most in
detecting or seeing that there is a dog
in the image now we also have the gray
cam for different models you see this
grad cam for the vgg model and we have
this resnet grad cam right here so we
see that two different models
can produce two different gray cams
though generally they should be similar
we see that with the rest net we'll have
this larger surface as compared to this
vgg and we could also see this for the
cat now that's set we are going to
implement the gray cam technique which
generates or which permits us to
generate this kinds of visualizations
which tell us what parts of the input
influence the model in taking certain
decisions
as we could see in this figure 2 from
the paper
given an image and a class of interest
for example the tiger cat or any other
type of differentiable output so um like
here we have this image you see the
image and we're given the class tiger
cat
so yeah the task is classif in image
classification so here we have this
class tiger cat now
um for now we'll keep out this here
we'll focus only on this image
classification so essentially we have
this image as we said already we we have
the class then we pass this through a
CNN that's a convolutional neural
network
you have that right here where Let's see
we forward propagate the image to the
CNN part of the model remember
um this CNN has already been trained so
we follow this to the CNN part of the
model and then through the tax specific
competitions to obtain a raw score for
the category so that specific year in
our case our test is image
classification so this year is specific
to
um our task which is that of image
classification now the gradients are set
to zero for all classes except the
desired class
then the signal is then back propagated
to the rectified convolution of future
maps of Interest
so you could see from here that when we
propagate this into our CNN we have this
output feature Maps here you have
rectified conf feature Maps so these are
feature maps and then we pass this
through this fully connected layers then
we obtain the outputs from here we bump
up and get as we said already
to this rectified feature Maps
and you can see that the resultant of
this bad propagation is what we have
here notice how this color compared to
this so here's our feature Maps here's
the output from back propagation from
this output back up to this feature Maps
so we we obtain this by doing the
derivative of this output let's say y
let's say why tiger cut let's call it t
c y t c y tiger card with respect to
X feature Maps let's call it FM
so we find in our we Computing this
derivative of the output with respect to
each and every
um value we have here for the future
maps and obviously this will give us a
corresponding feature map just like
having uh let's let's begin a position
let's say this random position here we
take the output with respect to this we
take the output respect to another
position to the up respect to another
position and so on and so forth and by
doing this we reconstruct somehow those
feature Maps but this time around
um it's going to be the derivatives of
the output with respect to each and
every position
then from here as you could see let's
take this off
from here what we do is we are going to
obtain the mean for each and every one
of those features so you see this one
this one that's pinkish you have this
here so we obtain the mean of for this
we take for this we obtain this mean
um this and so on and so forth so we
obtain all this and so all these mean
values now are going to be multiplied by
those feature Maps so for this for
example this one here we'll take this
and multiply
um on this features we take this
multiply
those features and so on and so forth
then once we get this we're gonna
combine all this or
add all these features up and then pass
this through a relu function which then
produces a grad cam
and so that's how this works in theory
that's how we obtain this grant can we
have here let's dive into the code and
get this practically
so first things first we have this
efficient net D5 model we should get
trained already so we'll just um load
the weights let's go ahead and load
those weights so we have pretty model
load weights and there we go
from here we could test out the model so
we have this image here basically what
we've seen already in testing so we have
the test image
um we expand dimensions and then we have
the pre-trend model which now takes in
our image array so this is the output
right here you could see that the max is
at this
um index one which is logical because
it's a happy image we could um
see that right here the person is happy
so this is our image and here's what up
model produces remember as we've seen
already we have actually three classes
we have Angry happy and sad and
um this is a zeroth index
index one and index two so I'll put this
index one meaning this prediction is
correct
at this point if you could recall from
here this model was broken up into two
parts so we have let's take this off we
have this first part which generates
this feature maps and then this other
parts which takes in the feature maps
and then outputs
the specific class of this input image
but given that when defining our model
this was in a block that is we basically
Define this as one not as two separate
entities like this we are going to look
at how to
um separate this or better still how to
create a model which is made of only
this first part and then the model made
of this auto part
and then one thing you should note is
that the way we created this um model
was a bit different from what we had
seen so far so previously we'll get back
here with a speed trained models let's
get back modeling we have
free trained well let's pick this one
transfer learning with this you see that
we had a backbone defined
and then we have the backbone we have
glow average pulling and so on and so
forth and then when you look at the
summary if you look at the summary you
have all this represented as one so the
backbone was uh or you don't get into
the details of what is contained in the
backbone but now when you look at this
other summary let's get down to crack
cam when you look at this model summary
now you would find that all the details
of the backbone are given and this has
gotten differently because now what we
do is
the input are our X which is passing to
the global average Boolean is simply
this backbone dot output so when we say
when we specify that you want to get the
backbone output
um this
permits us get a summary with all the
details like this and then when it comes
to the inputs here you would say you
want to have the backbone inputs so
let's uh this input right here is
actually useless you need to take you
could take this off so that's it so once
you specify this and then you have your
usual output then you'd get this full
summary okay so that said now let's go
ahead and create uh
um make this model out of this full
model we have here
so in order to create this last conf
layer model which is essentially this
model year where would get the the
output to be this
um rectified con feature Maps
we have this Keras model which takes us
inputs the pre-train model inputs so
it's quite similar to what we had
already here where we'll just take the
inputs to be the backbone inputs now our
inputs is the full pre-trained model
inputs but then the outputs take notice
the output is this last
count layer output now what is this last
conf layer the last cons the last conf
layer
is that layer whose name is given as top
activation you'll notice that this is
um this last conflict where we have this
feature Maps it's eight by eight by 2048
and then from here we move on to the
global average Boolean then there's one
dance two and then we have our output so
this part from here
upwards is this initial uh conf layer
all this convolutional neural network
and then this year
is this classifier unit to the right
and so now that we have this name of
this last count layer that's the top
activation we are going to make use of
that to produce our outputs you see last
count layer is simply the pretend model
and we get the layer whose name is last
conf layer name and last conflict a name
stop Activation so we understand where
we get this top activation from so now
we have our last comp layer as I've said
already we are now able to have this
last comf layer model
or this
initial CNN model here which
um has as input the image and as output
the feature Maps so let's run this and
see what we get there we go we could we
could do last
conf layer model
and check out the summary
there you go you have this model
let's check out the outputs you see
here's the model output and
here is the models input
see
256 battery so we have the the input the
image and the output the feature Maps
now we've built this first model or
we've created this first model from our
overall model let's go ahead and check
out on our classifier model so for the
classifier model you see we have those
inputs the input now is going to be this
feature Maps remember the output of this
was the feature maps and the inputs of
this is the feature Maps
from here given that we have the inputs
to this classifier model we are going to
Simply
pass this through each and every layer
which makes up the classification part
of the pre-trained model so if we get
back up here let's scroll back up you'll
notice that we had this global average
Boolean we had this dance we have dense
one we have this dance two which all
make up the classifier path so let's get
back here and then you see this
classifier layer names is given here so
we understand where those names are
coming from and then we simply go
through for every layer name in our
classifier layer names so let's have
this so for every layer name in our
classifier layer names we are going to
pass the inputs those inputs
classifier inputs into these layers so
we take this input pass into the global
average pooling then the the output will
be X we take that again pass this into
the dance then we'll take that again
pass into dance one and then pass into
dance two and then we have the outputs
which is in this case X so our input is
the classifier input which is this and
our output is the output after we pass
this input through this different layers
the count block
and the classification unit designed the
next step will be to compute the partial
derivatives of the output with respect
to the features here now we could
compute this partial derivatives or
these gradients making use of this
gradient method which takes in the top
class Channel
and the last conf layer output so this
year
is our top class and then here we have
our feature Maps
to obtain this feature marked as this
last conflict layer output we simply
pass the inputs that's the image into
our last config layer model our last
conflict a model just configure all this
conf model right here take the input
pass in here open the feature map so
here's our feature maps and then from
the future Maps we pass this through our
classifier model so we take the
classifier we take the feature Maps pass
the classifier model obtain the
predictions here 10 those predictions
and then get the top prediction index
now the stop prediction index uh will
depend on our example now given that um
the the person is happy we expect this
index value to be equal one so we could
we could even pin this out let's print
this out top prediction index there we
go so we will have this top Edition
index and then to obtain the exact score
we are going to Simply Peak
that score from the predictions so here
we have the pretz obviously the Press is
from this so we have the pretz and then
uh by specifying top red index or by
simply specifying one what we're saying
is we want to get this car when we pass
this input
um into this classifier model and now
this call we we're talking about here
should be what we had right here so
should be this value right here so we're
Computing the partial derivative of the
output with respect to the feature maps
and we're making use of this gradient
method to help us do that so let's take
this off you see here we have this here
there we go we run this and then we
obtain this output shape you see takes
the exact shape of the feature Maps
then once we have this year this is
Regions the next thing we could do is
simply obtain the mean values at every
position right here so uh we'll simply
make use of this reduce mean
while specifying the axis so let's run
this and print out our pulled grad ship
there we go you see we have 2048 so
basically this Vector now where each
position
is a mean of a single Channel remember
from here we had
2048 channels and each and every one of
them was eight by eight so you should oh
we could say one by eight by eight so we
had this
for each and every channel and now we've
reduced each and every one of this into
a single value so this is just a single
value this is a single value which we
have here which we'll see here
essentially and so now we have this
2048 dimensional vector and that's what
we're seeing here so this is essentially
this now the next step will be to take
this here and multiply by our feature
Maps
to carry out that multiplication we'll
simply go for Iron Range 2048 so for
each and every one of those different
positions we have here we are gonna
take the corresponding last conflict
layer output which is essentially those
feature Maps so we take the feature map
you see we specify I so if zero then
we're taking this feature map of this
Channel and then multiplying by its
corresponding pulled grads which we've
seen already to be the mean of each and
every
um Channel we have here for this
gradients so that's how we obtain this
now note that we we specify that wonders
zero element because this is one by
eight by eight by 2048 and specifying
this will leave us with a tensor of
shape 8 by 8 by 2048 so we get rid of
this here so that said we now run this
and we obtain our
last count layer output so it's going to
be obviously the same shape you could
see check that out last count layer
output shape
and there we go
now to obtain the heat map we are going
to sum up the values at different
positions for all the channels so let's
suppose that we have something like this
this is for example three channels then
this position see we have this position
we'll take this plus this plus this and
then we'll have this output then we move
to the next position this
plus this plus this and then we have
this and so on and so forth so that's
how we're going to go from this eight by
eight by number of channels output or
let's say 2048 output to an eight by
eight
map so this is what we have here we're
going to sum this and specify the axis
as the channel axis so we run this
already and then now we could visualize
our heat map but uh notice that there's
also this value right here so we have
the relu before we visualize the heat
map
there we go here's our heat map which we
then resize using open series resize
method
so you see how we get from this heat map
which was 8x8 to this one which is 256
by 256 and the reason why we're doing
this is because we want to add this with
the image of purpose this on the image
such that we have an output
which shows us clearly where or better
still regions of the image where we have
the highest contribution to our output
which is that of a happy person so the
model operators that this person is
happy and now we know which parts of the
image contributed the most to that
prediction
now trying out with a different image
and modifying this slightly so that we
could get this image here we find that
is this part so previously it was a
small region now is this Zone we you see
this wrinkles right here we have this
Zone and this Zone which influenced the
prediction
and with this we've just implemented
this grad cam method thank you for
getting up to this point and see you in
the next section
hi there and welcome to this new and
exciting session in which we shall be
treating or we shall be using this
Transformer Network right here to solve
problems in computer vision
and more specifically in the task of
image classification
up onto this point we've seen different
convolutional neural networks like the
Lunette the vgg the resnet the mobile
Nets the efficient net and now we'll be
looking at the vision Transformers this
Vision Transformers were first developed
in this paper entitled an image is what
16 by 16 words where the build
Transformers for image recognition at
scale in this section we'll take a deep
dive into how this whole architecture
has been constructed and how it works
and also how and why Transformers
perform as well as their convolutional
neural network counterparts the very
first point you want to note here is the
usage of Transformers for computer
vision tasks has
been developed in very recent times you
could see here from this date this paper
was published
the authors see here that while the
Transformer architecture has become the
de facto standard for natural language
processing tests is application to
computer vision remains limited Envision
attention is either applied in
conjunction with the convolutional
networks are used to replace certain
components of convolutional networks
while keeping their overall structure in
place
we show that this Reliance on the
convolution on neural networks is not
necessary and a Pew Transformer that
without any convolutional neural
networks applied directly to sequences
of image patches can perform very well
on image classification texts they even
go ahead and tell us that when
pre-trained on large amount of data and
transferred to multiple mid-sized or
small image recognition benchmarks like
the imagenet Sci-Fi
that is a vision Transformer attains
excellent results compared to the
state-of-the-art conf Nets like the
efficient net while requiring
substantially fewer computational
resources to train now it's possible
that you've never heard of this term
Transformer or maybe you from an
electrical engineering background and
you've only heard of this when it comes
to stepping up and stepping down
electric power now we are gonna go
straight away to explain terms like the
transformer or even this attention which
was mentioned to better understand the
Transformer and the role it has to play
in this vit architecture right here we
would have to get back in time to
understand why do we first developed in
2017 this paper entitled attention is
all you need was first developed by
verse 1 year out and it has turned out
to be one of the most influential paper
is in the modern deep learning ERA with
the development of this Transformer
architecture right here at the heart of
this Transformer architecture we have
this self-attention models and more
specifically in this paper they used the
scale.product attention that we could
see here but then as we said the whole
purpose of the domain in which these
kinds of architectures all those kinds
of networks were built was for natural
language processing but the question is
how does this work in natural language
processing to understand how and why the
attention and also the Transformers are
used in natural language processing will
take the following example which is that
of translation which we used to already
doing with Google translate so here
we're gonna put in I love the weather or
could you see the weather today is
amazing and we translate this to French
now initially the kinds of deep learning
techniques which were used in solving
these kinds of problems that is taking
us from one language to another
where the recurrent neural networks
the way this recurrent neural networks
work is quite simple so we'll start by
putting the text here
here we'll put out our example from
Google translate and then we've added
this extra blocks right here now those
blocks we've seen here are recurrent
neural network blocks recording neural
networks generally reading rnns here are
one of the first deep learning based
models used in natural language
processing types like the case of
translation we have here now the way
this works is we have our initial text
or we have a source that's English text
the weather today is amazing and then we
have the target which we want to
generate so initially we have this input
and this output which we're going to
train and later on when we pass in some
random input we expect to get a
reasonable output now the way we have
this or the the way this is structured
is such that each and every one of this
is called a token so we have this word
here which is a token this this is our
first token next token this token this
token and this other token then this
different tokens have been converted
into vectors and then been passed in
this RNN blocks right here now we carry
out some simple computations like
multiplication and addition and then
some information has been passed in from
one block to another hence the term the
recurrent neural network now the
importance of passing information from
one block to another is that this tokens
computations in this block will depend
on this other previous tokens that you
could see here so it depends on this
depends on this and also depends on this
other one and then once we're done with
conver or passing this information from
one block to another after this we are
then going to take this here we're going
to have some information we're going to
be passed onto this other
RNN block here so this is our encoder
block so here we encode the information
and then yeah we decode this information
so here we have the encoder and the
decoder and then again your similar
process is repeated where we have this
computations which produce an output
here and then we could take this output
and feed it in this one to produce this
other output and so on and so forth up
to this final output but then the
problem with this technique or with this
method is that first of all if we have a
very long text then it may happen that
it has become in difficult for
information to flow from this first
blocks here to this final blocks and
given that even as humans we know the
importance of taking into consideration
some previous context when trying to
carry out a text like for example
translation
this kind of problem will lead to very
poor results
now another problem here is each time
with training we have to
ask this information from one block to
another sequentially so here we pass all
this information sequentially and
because this information is passed
sequentially it makes it difficult for
us to implement parallelization very
efficiently
and so this makes the training of this
kind of neural networks very difficult
now to tackle the issue with long-term
dependencies attention networks were
developed so right here instead of
depending on just this final Vector we
get or this final output we get from
this hidden layer here which has been
passed on here to relay this information
from the source to the target language
what we'll do is for each and every unit
we have here each and every recurrent
neural network block we have here we are
going to take into consideration inputs
from each and every block here so this
inputs will be taken into consideration
so each and every block now
you see all of this is passed and then
we have this attention layer right here
which then processes this inputs from
this different uh Source rnm blocks such
that the layer that all this attention
layer produces an output Vector which is
now passed as input into this RNN block
and so when we have this source and this
target we pass in the source then we get
all
we combine those inputs from each and
every RNN block right here pass in this
as input into this uh rnm block get an
output in this case is Le
then we take this output and
pass it as an input in your but again
once we shift and go to and get to this
time where all this time frame where we
want to get this second output what
we'll do is we'll have another
tension year
which again takes in all these different
inputs so we'll take again all these
different inputs here
and here and year and year
then carry out some computations based
on the type of attention we are
implementing and then from here we get
an output which is passed together with
this Lu right year so from here we get
this output and then we repeat the same
step that's passing in the the turn that
is taking this output passing in here
and then also taking in this inputs from
this different RNN blocks
and so as you can see here for each and
every block we have here it pays
attention to each and every input
and for this uh from this we could even
come up with an attention map where we
would have uh this text this text in
English the weather today is amazing
and then this other side we have Luton
inquired so now
after training this kind of model we can
be able to see how much attention this
Le pays to each and every input year
and
it's about logical that this layer will
pay the most attention to the and then
actually uh years weather so this will
pay more attention to our most attention
to weather then pay most attention to
today is today eh will pay most
attention to is and inquire will pay
most attention to amazing
and if we get to this paper entitled
neural machine translation by jointly
learning to align and Translate
that is a famous burden now in our paper
you can see some of this attention Maps
here let's have this
you see some of these attention Maps
there you see
uh la la causula Zone economic European
it is
an end then the agreement on the
European economic area was signed in
August 1992. so you see this attention
Maps here where
we see clearly which words attend most
to one another
so here we have this image which shows
exactly what we're describing previously
so here you have this inputs and then to
get this output y of T you'll find that
we're going to take in or we're going to
attend to each and every input here and
then uh pass this year to obtain our YT
now at this point we are going to move
on from the attention to self attention
and to better explain the self-attention
we'll consider a whole different problem
which is that of sentiment analysis so
you want to we have this model okay we
could now take this off we don't uh make
use of this although you should note
that we still use our self attention in
the translation problems but it will be
easier to grasp this concept in the
context of sentiment analysis so yeah
what we are having is we we have the
weather today is amazing I want to be
able to say whether this is a positive
or negative statement
so now we have this model which takes in
inputs like this and then let's draw
this model here like this we have this
uh model and then
outputs or tells us whether the
statement we've made is a positive or A
negative statement
now here or for this self-attention or
layer we are not gonna need this
recurrent
neural network hidden States anymore
in fact what we could do is we would
take all this off actually because
basically we having this self-attention
model which we'll see in a minute uh how
it works
and then what we're present in here is
some vectors so we have this Vector we
have this other Vector we have this
Vector this one and finally this one now
if we combine all this we'll find out we
have a sequence length so we have one
two three four five suppose I also
because length is five so we have a
sequence length by
let's say embedding dimension
Matrix which we should get from here
now let me explain let's suppose that
the sequence line is 5 as we've all seen
and then the embedding Dimension is
let's say three
so we have this five by three Matrix
which we are going to pass into this
self attention layer right here
now
this embeddance or these vectors which
we pass into the self-attention unit are
gonna be designed in a way that Words
which look alike are gonna be close to
each other while Words which are
opposites are going to be far away from
each other
now let's uh since we're working in
three dimensions it means we'll have a
one two three values here one two three
and then finally here one two three
so let's let's do something like this
three dimensions
what we'll have is the word happy
which in this case can be represented by
this vector or this embedding would be
uh or can be plotted out like this and
this will be close to a word like smile
while a word like sad a word like sad
will be far away from this uh two words
because it actually opposites to each
other so we have sad and we could have
angry right here
now for this one here or for this text
here we could pick out these two words
which are most likely to be very close
to each other we could have the right
here and we have is somewhere around
here
and so now getting back to this model we
have this 5x3 input which is passed into
a self-attention layer so we could let's
let's have this Matrix here five by
three would have the the word there yeah
would have its own embedding so we will
have some value some value some value
let's suppose that we're working in
three-dimensional embedding and then
weather will have its own value its own
value it's on value today it's on value
this value this value could you could
take say 2.3 1 0.5 negative five one
Whatever value one year and then you
have this and you have this and you have
this this is four already and then
amazing would have its own so you see
that each and every one of this here has
its own embedding so this is these are
the different words we have here then at
this point we'll Implement a spatial
type of attention in known as a DOT
product attention where we'll take this
year and multiply it by the transpose of
a matrix which has the same shape at
this Matrix here so we'll take this
we'll call this the query and then we'll
multiply this by the transpose of the
key now this key is going to be three by
five since it's going to have the same
shape as this query now this is our
query we'll call this a query and so
here now we have
um this three by five metrics
and then this product would give us a
five by five metrics now after this
after getting this 5x5 Matrix we could
pass this through a soft Max layer now
we've looked at the soft Max layer in
previous sessions but uh one thing you
should note here is once we have this
5x5 Matrix it produces this attention
map
similar to what we have seen before
where we have this the weather today is
amazing to the side and the same again
to the side and then Words which are
most similar to each other in a certain
context are going to have the highest
values and so if we're in the case where
you had uh say let's replace this
weather by happy and then we have uh
amazing Let's uh let's let's live
amazing so if we have the happy today's
amazing uh it sure doesn't make sense
but let's consider this let's suppose
that we have the happy today's amazing
then this uh second row of food column
because amazing will be around here so
we will have this value which is going
to be relatively higher than all the
other surrounding values and this will
be because after training the model the
attention map values would have been
modified such that
values or rather Words which are similar
to one another take higher values wire
Words which are not similar to one
another take very small values
now from here we have this uh 5x5 Matrix
which now were multiplied by another
five by three Matrix would give us a
five by three Matrix
generally we call this Matrix which is
multiplied by this attention Matrix the
value so we have query we have the key
and we have the value
and with this you see that we have this
input which got in here which was five
by three and now we have a 5 by 3 output
then this year now we pass through some
fully connected layers and then we'll
have an output or a fully connected
layer with one neuron's output which
will tell us whether an input statement
is a positive thin man or a negative
statement
and so as you've seen we've gotten read
completely of the recurrent neural
network blocks as now we're just making
use of this self attention blocks to
extract information from our inputs
now one of the first papers if not the
first paper which made use of just the
attention and getting rid of the rnns
was this attention is all you need paper
and it happens to be one of the most
influential papers in modern day deep
learning so yeah when this attention is
all you need the paper or the
Transformer paper to present this new
network which you could see just right
here
and then a single block let's take this
off a single block which makes up the
Transformer model is this multi-head
attention so as you could see right here
we have those uh single block and then
here we have this multi-head attention
so let's look at this multi-head
attention this actually the Motorhead
attention here so you have this year
which is this or
uh block and then in this multi-head
attention you have the skill dot product
attention which is this self-attention
we just talked about you see we have the
query the key and the value so since
it's self-attention you'll notice here
that we have those inputs and all these
come from the same input so we have this
uh input which is splitted up into QR K
and V query key and value now this
resembles
or is analogous to data management
systems where uh they're stored in key
value pairs just like uh say python
dictionary so you have theater in this
key value pairs uh data start this way
and then when you want a particular
information you have to pass in a query
now when you pass in the query let's
change this color or you pass in the
query you have a particular key which is
selected once the key is selected we now
obtain the value which is the data
itself and it's uh kind of similar to
what we have in your
and then from here in this level of the
split note that uh before the
information has been passed into this
skill dot product attention we actually
passed this cure knv into some different
linear layers and so this means that
even though we have the same inputs
they'll end up being
projected into three different inputs
and so now we have this QR KV
we are going to carry out qrk transpose
here we have the matte Mall as we saw
already KR * K transpose
and then we have this scaling
which you can see right here in this
formula of this attention formula we
have qkt divided by this DK
then from here we have soft Max of all
this and then we multiply by V so let's
get back up to this year
that's fine
now that we have this output you now see
that we have this multi-head so we we
got this we have the soft Max we have
the map mall where we take this soft Max
of this multiply it by V so that's how
we get this recall how we saw that with
the example we had previously and then
we have this multi-head attention now
this multi-head attention here simply
means you take this year as you pass in
your information like this you get this
cure K and V and then you again pass the
same information into this block so
let's suppose that this is our skill dot
product attention block this is kill dot
product attention which is right inside
here and so once we have this let's
let's make that smaller let's suppose
that this is what we have here so this
year is actually this now to obtain a
multi-head attention we would have this
other one year
and then we'll have let's suppose that
we have three heads if we have three
heads then we would have three of this
stacked in this way you have one two
let's change the color so it becomes
clearer we have this one in red we have
this next one in blue
here
and then we have this other one in green
so there we go we have this three and
then when the information gets in so you
have your cure you have your K and you
have your V we pass this through uh this
separate linear layers see for for each
of this we have some linear layer
here
all of this came from the same inputs as
you could see here and then now this
information is passing so we have QR KV
passed into this one into this block
here and then this same qrkv also is
passed into let's change the color
we will now have some other here some
other linear layers let's put it resize
this we have some other linear layers
here we'll pass V we will pass K we'll
pass here right here and then this now
will be set into this self attention
block right here then we also finally
have this for the red so it would have
something like this red we have the k
something like this we have the V
something like this so now this qrkv is
passed now into this red here
and that's it and then the outputs here
the outputs we'll get at the end of this
three self-attention blocks will now be
concatenated and then passed through a
linear layer so this linear layers is
like our dense layer intensorflow now
once we have this you see we have our
multi-head attention which is this block
and then now we'll take this input added
on to the output and then go through a
layer normalization then from here we we
pass this through a feed forward network
uh that's like our fully connected
Network or dense layer and then we'll
get again repeat this addition and
normalization a little similar to what
we have with the rest Nets now once we
have this now
we could repeat this n times
now you notice that this is similar to
this except for the fact that now we
have this two multi-head attentions and
we also have this maxed anyway we're not
going to get into all those details
what's important for you to understand
how this encoder here works
and now you understand how this works
when I get back to our wheat paper that
is this paper entitled Transformers for
image recognition at scale
and now you should be able to understand
this Transformer block which we
presented earlier in this paper with
this understanding of how this
Transformer encoder Works let's now get
into this uh unit year where we break
this image into this different patches
as we could see right here
to better understand how and why we make
use of patches right here let's not
forget that what does Transformer
encoder takes in is some input sequence
so we have this input here uh initially
we had words where each word like this
could be represented by this vector or
this embedded vector and then
this now combined is passed into the
Transformer
here since our input is this image in
order for us to represent it this way we
will have to break this up so what we
could do or what we could think of at uh
First Sight is we have this image let's
suppose the image is 2 56 by 256.
by C3 3 channels then we could take each
and every pixel here so let's let's omit
the the channel for the channels for now
so what we could have here is for each
and every pixel in this 256 by 256 image
we would have a vector representing that
pixel and then this other one is Vector
this is what I want is Vector and so on
and so forth but don't forget that
unlike previously where we had only five
words now we have
256 times 256 words because if we have
an image like this and we have to get
each and every pixel then we'll have 256
by 256
which is more than 65
000 different uh
vectors which we'll have to pass here
and so
before where in our attention model we
had an attention map which was five by
five recall we saw that already with the
words we had a five or an input sentence
with five words we had five five
attention map now would have a 65 000 by
65 000 attention map you see that
working with these kinds of matrices and
memory isn't very feasible and so
instead of going pixel by pixel the
authors decide to work patch by patch
Let's uh increase this again so you get
to see that take this off you see where
we go patch by patch so you could see
um how this image instead of taking uh
each pixel we break this up into patches
so this is not like a pixel and then you
see this patch you see this patch this
patch this other patch this patch and so
on and so forth after this patch right
here now this is what uh is like the
word now here so with images we have to
break this up like this and the authors
choose to work with 16 by 16 pixel
patches so each Patcher is 16 by 16.
and so given that we have 16 by 16 if we
have this patch for example then we
would have
256 different pixels for each patch here
we have 256. here we have 256 and so on
and so forth so unlike with the images
or rather online with the words where we
had a five by three so we had five words
and each word was represented by a
three-dimensional Vector here each patch
is represented by 256 dimensional Vector
now this doesn't mean that in NLP we
generally work with this this was uh
just done to make it easier for you to
understand so getting back to computer
vision you see that we have this 256 256
256 and so on and so forth now when
working with the Transformer
we may not want to work with this 256
dimensional vectors maybe we want to
work with say uh 512 dimensional vectors
in that case we would have to do this
linear projection of the flattened
patches such that we leave from this
um say let's suppose that we have one
two three we have nine patches so the
sequence line is nine so we have this
input which is 9 by 256 and then after
going through this linear projection we
now get to 9 by 512 and this will be the
embedded dimension for our Transformer
in the previous example our embedded I
mentioned was three so if this this
permits also be to to work flexibly as
now we could decide on uh what size we
want for our embedded dimension now that
said we have this output you see nine by
512 and then we're ready to pass this
into the Transformer encoder but just
before passing this would add this
position embeddance you see there we we
have this inputs you see in this
different this color you have them
getting in and then we have this
position embeddance here is notice zero
one two three and up to nine now the way
this works or or let's start by first
the reason why we even have to do this
is because unlike with the confidence
where
whether convolutional or the way the
convolutional neural networks work is
that
for computing the feature Maps it takes
into consideration locality so this
means that you see these two portions
here
um
when passed with a conf filter will
produce a certain output and so this
means that
pixels which belong to a certain uh to a
small locality like this one will be
used to produce the output
and this clearly gives an uh gives the
cnns an upper hand over the Transformers
as
when trying to understand an image the
positions of particular pixels actually
matter
so this means that
cnns already have an inductive bias due
to the way they actually work
and so to give a help in hand to the
Transformer network will now need or
will need this position embedding
which gives this Transformer encoder an
idea of the location of each and every
patch which is passed in
but again it should be noted that this
will have to be learned uh automatically
by the model
now if you notice we have this extra
input right here and the reason why we
have this extra input is simply because
we do not want the situation where after
going through this encoder all this
Transformer encoder right here we pick
one of this
outputs because we would have outputs
here we don't we don't want to pick one
of these outputs to be used for the MLP
head or to be used for this fully
connected Network
in this classification unit right here
So to avoid this uh sort of
bias where would be picking one of this
the authors add this extra learnable
class embedding right here
which will be uh or whose output will be
passed into this MLP head and then will
be used for classification
another important point to note here is
the Transformer encoder or this or
visual Vision Transformers
are some sort of hybrid architecture
because we may decide not to pass in
those image patches directly but instead
passes image patches through a
convolutional neural network then get
the output embeddings and pass in your
directly instead of this image patches
it should be noted that the multi-layer
perceptron contains two fully connected
layers with a yellow non-linearity
here's the general
linearity uh compared to the relu and
the yellow so you see we have this relu
where all values less than zero over
less than zero uh gives output of zero
and all values greater than zero give
the exact same value but with the jellu
we have this curved function right here
so that's it
the type of normalization is the layer
normalization as we mentioned already
and the layer normalization here we
could visualize this in this paper by
sharing it all or entitled power Norm
reaching batch normalization in
Transformers where you see we let's Zoom
this
you see we have layer normalization here
and we have the batch normalization put
side by side so or with the layer
normalization as we were saying
if you consider some inputs let's let's
here we have the sequence length or the
sequence Dimension we have the features
of the embeddance or like a vector
actually so we have the different
vectors and then we have the batch
Dimension so basically what we're saying
is we have in this sequence length uh we
have this different vectors here
which have been passed into
some layer and then instead of doing or
carrying a normalization for for
throughout the batches as is in the case
of the batch Norm here we carrying out
this normalization for each and every
vector
and the reason why we do not use the
batch Norm with the Transformers is the
fact that the batch statistics for NLP
data have a very large variance
throughout training
and this variance exists in the
corresponding ingredients as well and So
to avoid this kind of situation
it's preferable for us to carry out this
normalization on the features instead
before we move on to the experiments
let's look at how the widths are being
used in real world
so actually the vids are pre-trained on
very large data sets and fine-tuned to
smaller Downstream tasks
obviously when fine tuning we remove
this head and replace with a head which
now correspond to our number of classes
so this means that initially we may have
a thousand class head and then we move
this to K classes
or let's say three class head
to better understand why we're going
from uh why we have a d by K output
let's uh get back here so after those
inputs have been passed in here we have
an output sequence length plus one this
plus is one year
let's just say we have here we have
say from here L1 by D output if if we're
considering all the sequence length will
be a sequence length by the output this
D here is our
embedding dimension
which we had fixed from this linear
projection right here so we have this um
one by D and then uh we pass this
through obviously it becomes it becomes
like simply uh the neurons so we have
one two we now have D neurons since it's
just one by D and then we have this
output let's say we have a thousand
classes then we'll have this fully
connected layer which uh brings all this
here this the inputs to this K outputs
or in this case to this 1000 outputs now
well we want to fine tune one one of
fine tune we are going to take this off
take this off and replace this now with
K outputs so we now have K outputs right
here
and then we initialize this weight of
this fully connected layer
the authors also make mention of the
fact that during fine tuning is better
to work at higher resolutions so this
means that the model could be traded at
256 by 256 and then later on fine-tuned
with 512 by 512 images
and then since they keep the patch size
the same this results in a larger
effective sequence length now let's
explain or let's visualize this
statement so here we have this input
which is say 48 by 48. let's say we have
here 48 by 48 and when we divide this or
we'll break this up into three parts we
have 16 16 16 16
16. so we have 16 by 16 patches now if
you want to fine tune
on a higher resolution image then
uh let's say the higher resolution
images say 96 by 96 so it could have
something like this so if now we're fine
on the 96 by 96 image and that we still
maintain the fact that this year or the
patches will be 16 by 16 then this means
that instead of three year we're going
to have six so we now have or one two
three
four
five and six patches six patches this
way two
three
four five six and so on and so forth so
now we're gonna have
um 36 different patches instead of nine
patches as we have here and that's why
they make mention of the fact that the
sequence length is going to be increased
and that's uh so long as they can fit in
the memory
now due to these modifications the
pre-trained that's what we had before
the between position embeddings May no
longer be meaningful
so they therefore perform 2D
interpolation of the pre-trained
position and variance according to their
location in the original image
the experiments here we we could see
those different models they have the vid
base the vid latch and the huge number
of parameters 86 million to 632 million
then here we have 12 layers recall let's
get back here recall we have this number
of layers here so basically you're
repeating this you're repeating this
here 12 times
so we'll get back so there we have 12
layers for the vid base as stated here
and then we have 24 for the large and 32
for bit huge now this hidden size this D
this embedded Dimension is 768 for base
1024 for large and
1280 for huge
uh the MLP size that's uh fully
connected layers uh to 3072
4006 yeah 5120 then the number of heads
remember the attention heads 12 16 16.
the experiments were carried out on this
gft 300 medium did set
I will see how this 14 by 14 patch
version of the vit outperforms this
resnet 152.
now this uh performance although not
largely uh greater than that of the
resnets
requires less computation resources to
train as we see here we have 2500
TPU core days required to train this
model as compared to this one which
requires 9900
TPU core days
also from this plots you see that when
you increase the number of pre-training
samples
the model which performs the best is
this Veet right here see here we have
this Veet and this outperforms the rest
Nets whereas uh for a reduced number of
samples the resonates outperforms the
beats
while here the smaller the patch size
like here we have this Fortune 14 by 14
per size we have the better the results
now in order to understand the reason
why as you increase this uh data set
size the bits start to outperform the
confidence
we have to recall that when working with
confidence like the resnet there is some
inductive buyers in the sense that
the fact that this resnet takes as input
this two-dimensional image
already gives this confident a helping
hand when it comes to extracting
features from your
and so even with relatively smaller data
sets this confidence can make sense out
of this input image
now with the Transformers which are some
sort of
generic neural network the model doesn't
get to see the image in this its natural
form what it sees is some patches which
have been converted to some vectors
and so at the very beginning or with
small theater the Transformer model
finds it difficult to make much sense
out of this patches
but as soon as we increase this data set
to considerable amounts
this Transformer model
now free of the inductive bias can even
do better than the confidence
and interesting enough you'll notice
that after training a Transformer model
this position embeddance we call the
position embeddings which are added onto
the patch and variance before passing to
the Transformer
actually learn on their own to
encode the position of the patches you
could see from this uh plot here where
we have the input patch row and the
input patch column you see that this uh
one one you see the position this is
Garden by the model or this is learned
automatically by the model during the
training process you see two one it goes
a step in the direction and maintains
this direction or maintains a row and
you see three one maintains a row but
goes three steps you see this
you see you see that and then finally
here you go you go to seven steps to the
right and then seven steps uh downward
then year to the left you could look at
this you see this
um this embedded filters right here we
have this embedded filters which we see
here which look much alike to the The
Confident filters then to the right you
have this plot
which summarizes the reason why the vits
end up being more powerful than the
confidence
to understand this let's take this year
who will consider confident with a given
depth now with the confidence the
initial layers let's let's have this
Koff net and we break this up so we
break this up we have our initial layers
and then we have our final layers this
initial layers parameters extract low
level features while those final layers
per minute extract high level features
and so if we have an image like this
like this one and we have this head and
we have this then
given that we're passing this filters of
this kaufnet filters here you'll see
that this pixel for example
attends to this other pixels which are
found around its locality
and then as we go deeper in the network
we would have the speaker which now
tries to attend to this other pixel year
which is
much more far away from it
to better picture this remember the
example we took for three or rather two
three by three filters compared to a
single five by five filter let's let's
draw this here we compared this with a
single 5x5 filter and we saw that
although this 5x5 filter had a larger
receptive field compared to a single 3x3
filter which we have here
making or stacking up this three by
three filters that is making our Network
deeper permitted us to still be able to
capture this uh part of the image
and so this shows us that uh with the
curved Nets the earlier layers
when the when is not yet deep enough
we're still capturing this local
information and then as we go deeper we
start capturing much more Global
Information
and so if we have this kind of plot here
where this we have mean attention
distance and here we have the network
depth would see that for a confident
will keep increasing this up to a point
where we may we will no longer be able
to continue increasing because uh as
this this network depth all this we
increase the number of layers
we are able to capture much more Global
features and so this
um mean attention distance keeps
increasing
but with the attention or with the
Transformers since each patch attends to
each and every other patch
as we have seen already with the
self-attention each and every patch will
attend to uh the other right from the
very first attention layer we are not
going to have this but instead this plot
we have here
and so this means that if we train our
vit with a very large data set right
from the very first layers we are able
to capture both the local
and the global
features
and this is what makes the beats
more powerful compared to the covenants
when we work with big dealer
here we can also visualize what the
model sees by looking at this attention
Maps you'll notice that after training
the model you see we have this attention
here see here these are pixels which pay
much attention to one another so here
this pixels are paying uh attention or
much more attention to one another as
compared to the other pixels in summary
to understand or to visualize what goes
on when training to CNN and vit models
side by side you'll see here that with
the vids as you increase this that aside
this increase data side and this is
increased in size here so as we increase
the the data size or rather when we
start with small data sizes we have this
kind of accuracy while for the cnns we
already have reasonable accuracies even
with small digit size and then as we
keep increasing this data size as we can
increasing this data size you see this
accuracy keeps increasing while for the
cnns
start to Plateau at some point
and this plateauing is simply comes due
to the fact that this CNN's here are
limited by the inductive biases whereas
this Transformers which are more generic
neural networks are free to learn even
better from this larger data sets
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we shall
be building our own vit model from
scratch
in the previous section we saw how this
Transformer model which previously was
used for NLP tests
could be used in computer vision with
proper preparations
and so in the section we'll see how to
convert or create patches of this image
and then carry out those linear
projections and pass this output from
those linear projections into the
Transformer encoder to then create or to
then train an end-to-end model which
learns how to see whether and input that
image is that of an angry person a happy
person or a sad given that we've been
working with 256 by 256 images if we
have to split up these images into 16 by
16 images then would have
256 different images because here if you
have
256 here and then uh break this up year
into 16 by 16 so here you have 16 pixels
by 16 pixels then you would have to go
you have to do the 16 times horizontally
and 16 times vertically to form a 256 by
256 image and so
um from here you would have
256 different patches like this one
and so what we'll use to create this
patches will be this extract patches
method right here now those extract
patches takes in the image
it takes in uh the sizes takes in the
stripes and the rates with also the
pattern so let's look at how this works
uh from here we have this picture here
or we have this output which will help
us picture how this works but before
looking at that let's uh look at this
arguments we have the sizes or we have
the images for the tensor we have uh the
sizes which specifies the
patch sizes so in our case we have a 16
by 16 patches so our patch size will be
16 we also have the strides which tells
us how much we should shift while
creating this patches and then we have
the rates which will better understand
with some figure so let's let's now get
back to this year and then we see that
we've been we we here we pass in the
sizes of one three three one so this
list we passing in here we got this from
here so you see we told it must be this
list where we have one the size Row the
size column and one but since the size
row equal size column equals 16 then
here would have 16 by 16. now in the
case where we have three three it you
you could see here let's let's have this
here
you could see here let's take this off
you could see here that we have this
three by three so you're online uh with
our example where we're working with 16
by 16 pixels here they have three by
three pixels and then
um the next one you have the strides
five by five now you'll notice that
let's scroll this way you will notice
that
when this box or when we want to get the
next patch we shift or we go five steps
to the right and then get this next uh
position of this next patch right here
so you can see after shifting we get to
this so originally we had this image
here and then we're trying to get these
different patches now the patches are
what we have in Stars you can see and
then again we shift uh five steps
downward we go downward again and then
we get to this
you'll see that you can count this one
two three four five steps and then we
get to this and then we shift again and
so on and so forth so that's how we
obtain all this uh three these four
patches right here now the next uh thing
we'll look at will be this
um rates now the rates again
um you have this one and this one and
then you specify this to read values
here now we'll look at or we understand
this two read values by looking at a
dilation or by looking at a dilated
convolution operation we can see this
visualization from this medium posed by
Sig hot sun where unlike with the usual
convolutions where when we're having
this filter which passes through the
image you see we have this three by
three filter which is compact here see
there's no space in between each element
of the filter but with a dilated
convolution you see the space in here so
it's kind of similar to what we will
have here as uh let's get back to
documentation
as with
um this if we decide to have patches
where
there is some spacing between the pixels
then we could specify how much space we
want with this rates right here now the
pattern here is set to valid
and so this means that if some pattern
needs to be done to match up with the
extraction then it will be done
automatically
now that said we could copy this uh out
copy this simply and then we paste it
out right here so here we have this and
then we'll call this patches
so we have this patches and then we'll
pass in our test image right here
there we go we have test image that's
fine and then here we have 16 by 16. now
this is the patch size so we could do
well to put that in the configuration so
we could we we could add that to the
configuration and the stride in 2016
because we want to let's get back here
the strident let's see why we need to
stride in 316 now you see that we're
interested if we have this kind of image
we're interested in we are not
interested in skipping this part so we
do not want to skip any parts we want to
have this
then we want to have this next
you see this is what we want to do then
we want to have this next
and this next obviously there'll be
padding year and year so we'll account
for the space here and then we want to
have this next and so on and so forth so
because we want to have this we'll make
this value to be the same as this search
that when we have this 3x3 patch we skip
three steps and move to this next and so
on and so forth so that said if you want
to have this kind of compact patch
extraction then you want to have this
this the value here for the stride the
same as the size so with that now let's
configuration patch size we have that
the 16x16 that's fine and then now let's
run this here let's Also let's run this
here this image this image and once
that's fine we run this we get this
error let's check out it must be four
dimensional okay so what we'll do is
instead of taking this test image we
will do expand themes so we create this
extra dimension
and then we add this to the zeroed axis
so we add this extra Dimension run that
again you see we have our patches now uh
look at what we're gonna have when we
print out the patches shape patches that
shape what do we get
see we have this 16 by 16 by 768 now
let's explain why we have this now
recall that we have a 256 by 256 by 3
image meaning that we're going to have
three channels like this
256 by 256
then by three now since we're dealing
with patches I think it is preferable we
should take this at once so this is 16
by 16 patch uh 16 by 16 patch
here we have the 16 by 16 patch
and then yeah again we have the 16 by 16
patch right here so now we have this
three 16 by 16 patches
and then given that each and every one
of those patches is 16 by 16 and 16 by
16 is 256. you'll see that if we pick a
given patch like here is a 16 by if a
picket 16 by 16 patch then this third
dimension will be 768 simply because for
each patch we have
256 pixels per channel so here we have
16 by 16 256 pixels which make up this
patch
now this other one 256 and this one 256
and now if you sum this up
it gives you 768 and that's how this
value is gotten
now to plug this out we are going to go
through each and every patch so we will
take this
both vertically and horizontally we
create the subplots
16 by 16 because we'll have 16 by 16 uh
different subplots and then for each
subplot we have this image you see here
we pick i j we pick a given patch out of
this 256 patches we pick that patch and
then we're going to reshape this because
when you pick this patch you're left
with this 768 year when you pick the
patch you're left with this pixels which
have all been flattened out to this 768
uh dimensional Vector that we calculated
here and so now what we need to do is
reshape this back into a 16 by 16 by 3
pixel obviously 16 by 16 by 3 will give
you 768 and so that's it let's run this
now you could always increase this
figure size or reduce it depending on
how you want to view this so run this
this what we get is output
there we go we see this image which
initially was compact now we're breaking
this up into uh several patches now
before we go on to create our patch
encoder which is this whole section
right here what we'll have to do is
convert or reshape these patches here so
uh recall that in this paper after doing
this here that's after creating those
patches we have to take each and every
one of them and this will be considered
as one element of the sequence so here
we have nine patches and here we have
nine values which have been passed or
nine different inputs or vectors which
will be passed here and so if we get
back here since we have 256 of this then
we'll need to reshape this such that
each and every one of this will be
considered as a part of us whole
sequence so here would print out let's
print out oh let's let's reshape that so
we have patches equals uh reshape and
then we have the patches and then this
will give us
patches that's a batch Dimension patches
shape zero then the next one with
negative one and then you will have
768. now either we put negative one or
we explicitly write 256. so this means
that we have uh decided to put this now
into uh 256 uh sequence length tensor
now with this let's print out the
patches shape and you see what that
gives us so here we have 256. now if we
put negative one year it's going to
automatically give us this 256. and
that's it so we we have this oh let's
let's rerun this so we get that
difference so you see here 2 16 by 16
and then 256 and that's it so each and
every one of those 256 now will be
passed into our Transformer now we could
modify this uh this plugin of the image
so let's let's have that and then we'll
say we have uh patches
shape uh one so we'll take 256 and then
yeah we have 16 by 16 and then we have
simply I plus one
okay so we have that we could take off
this K now we don't need this again take
that off and then yeah we have this eye
here which will now reshape into this
and this should be fine
so there we go let's run this again
and that's it we get exact same output
which is normal since we just uh
restructured those inputs so with this
we see that we are now set to create our
patch encoder layer and the splash
encoder layer will be similar to the
kinds of layers which we've been
creating so we could just copy this here
reduce that and then paste it out here
so we'll call this our patch encoder
layer there we go we have patch encoder
and your patch encoder so this patch
encoder will be responsible for first of
all converting our image into patches
and then
um
carrying out the projection and adding
the positional encoding
match encoder that's it
and now here we have this linear
projection which would
um create here so let's call this linear
linear projection and we could do this
with our dense layer so we have this
dense layer
stick that off
and then yours we could select our
hidden size dimensional embedding
Dimension now since our input is already
let's uh write this out here we have
inputs of uh let's take this off uh
batch Dimension or let's let's take the
by Dimension off we have inputs of 256
by 768 already so this is our Hidden
Side dimension for now but what we could
do is we convert this into 512 so let's
do just that uh we could let's now let's
let's take a 1024 let's make the model
bigger but this is too many parameters
already and it will take much time to
train so let's let's let's stay with
this okay so we stick with that and uh
let's get back to the code we're going
to specify our embedding dimension
oh let's say hidden size as this is in
the paper so our hidden size we specify
the hidden size and that's it we're
going to pass this in here we have
hidden size there we go
and uh we do not need this batch Norm we
have the linear projection we have this
hidden size okay let's leave it this way
for now so uh we have this call Meta we
should take this input and that will be
it we'll have this calculation which we
saw already here so we would have this
patches let's copy this from here okay
so we get the input we get this input
now this input will be getting here we
wouldn't need to do this expand themes
because the when training we already
have the batch Dimension so we'll just
have X let's call this in no let's let's
let's have that as X okay so we have
that X and that's fine then we'll do the
reshaping that's it and then from this
reshaping we'll have our output
output will be this uh patch which has
been projected to this new dimension and
so here we'll have output and uh it's
self
uh linear projection which takes in the
patches
then to make this value Dynamic we're
going to have let's take this off we're
going to have the patches shape uh
negative one so this value we have here
is the last dimension of all patches so
we have that and we get that last
Dimension now that we have the set we
now ready
to add up this positional embeddance we
had here so we will add this different
personal embeddance here onto a linearly
projected patches we should also note
that we are not going to take into
consideration this class embeddance
which I mentioned in the paper
as in practice this is not really
important we have your Lucas barrier
from the Google brain team which is the
main aim of including this was to
reproduce the exact Transformer network
but on image patches and so in practice
we are going to stick to this linear
projections the positional embedding now
will be constructed using tensorflows
embedded layer so here we have
positional embedding as described in the
paper embedding or encoding and then
here we have the embedding layer now
let's check out on how this embedded
layer is constructed or first of all
what's this about now this embedded
layer as described tfqrs layers
embedding turns positive integers
into dense vectors of fixed size
now getting back to the paper at this
point you see we have this linear
projections here we have this linear
projections which need to be added up to
the positioning coding which is this
once now the linear projection we're
going to get from here if we take if we
include the batch Dimension we'll have
an output which batch size by number of
patches so let's call this NP number of
patches because obviously we have this
patches here and each patch is going to
be a vector so it's number of Patches by
that last Dimension which in this case
is
768 so you could always fix this hidden
Dimension this is our hidden Dimension
let's say batch by NP by hidden
dimension
and then year stick this off
let's take a batch of one
so if we take a batch of one we would
have one for the batch Dimension then
the number of patches we would have will
be
256 because if we have 256 by 256 image
and we break it up into 16 by 16 pixel
patches then would have
256 different patches so here's what we
have for this one and now with the
embedded layer what we'll be able to get
will be another tensor which is like
this in the output of that embedded
layer and so as you can see here it
takes this indices and then turns them
into the dense vectors which we're
interested in now
um the arguments we have here the input
Dimension output Dimension initializers
regular Rises as we can see here and
then we can see this example where it
converts for example this number four
into this to the vector this uh index 20
into this other 2D vector and then from
this example which we could copy out and
test in our code Let's test this out
let's add this here
so we have this which we could test out
so you better you see better how it
works you see the model takes us input
this integer matrix by Dimension by
input length
and then give this other output
now in our case
since we're working with image data we
do not really have this vocabulary we
should talk about here
and so instead of this vocabulary
replaces by the number of patches
now if this were a natural language
processing then this will be the total
number of words that our model can treat
and so if we could have a vocabulary of
say 300 000 words and that's what we're
going to pass in this input Dimension
but as we said here we're going to take
this to be our number of patches now
this input Dimension is as I say the
dimension of the dense embedding
so in this case they put in the value 64
which will change to 768 shortly
now that said we will have this model
which is defined take that off we have
this input
you see the size of this input is 32 by
10 input there's a batch a dimension and
here are the different indices so we
have this input and then uh we're gonna
print out the ship from here so let's
run this
there we go you see it takes in this and
then outputs this one now as a vector so
basically what we have is we could have
uh let's take this off
what we have is
we have some indices
let's take this off we have some indices
let's say we have like in this case they
have 10 indices so we have this this
this this this this
as seven eight nine ten okay so here we
have this 10 indices and then oh another
by Dimension so we just have this 10
indices here so this 10 indices now
could
be projected into its two-dimensional
version where this one will be
represented by a vector so just like the
patches so you have a patch represented
by this Vector this one represented by
this Vector so this is no longer
represented by an index a let's say
because here this random values take
value between zero and one thousand so
it's no more a value like say uh 900 so
this maybe was 900 now will be converted
into a vector and the the size of this
Vector we see here will depend on this
value we set here so you see this this
means that this this this one here now
becomes a 64 dimensional vector and so
each and every one of this becomes 64
dimensional vectors and that's why we go
from uh this 10
to now 10 by 64 which you could see here
if we ignore it by dimension so uh what
we'll be doing in our case now
let's take this off what we're doing in
our case is we have this
768 and then here we have
um uh 256 and then the size of this
input
which is going to be some random input
we take the size to be
32 by 256 since we have 256 patches so
we have that 256. let's take this we
could take this off you could check out
the the reason why we we need the input
length documentation but for now we
don't need that so we have 32 by 256 and
then we expect to have an output which
is uh 32 by 256 Now by six by 768. let's
modify this let's take one uh by size of
one so let's run this which we have 1 by
256 by 768 and you see that it would
match now with this here with this here
from the projections or from the
positions of the inputs
now that said let's simply copy this
here we have this layer which we're
going to copy and at that year so
instead of this invariance we have this
embeddance there we go and then yeah
we'll pass in the number of patches so
here we have number of
patches
and then this one is this hidden size so
here again we have our hidden size and
that's it so now we have the hidden size
we get here and then uh instead of
having this we have this Plus
the positional encodings so we have
self.positional
embedding you could call that embedding
and then what this will take in will be
an input of length number of patches
so we get back here and then we would
have uh embedding
embedding inputs or we could use a TF
range and then we have the start we
could start from zero this the other
indices so we have this and then we have
the limit
our limit is going to be the number of
patches because we we want to get uh
these indices going from the
zero value to some end value such that
the length of this uh
tensor we're going to create is going to
be such that is equal the number of
patches so our limit years number of
patches in that sense we could have this
here so we have number of patches
already from here so we could get self
uh number of patches
there we go we have number of
number of patches okay so we have our
number of patches
that looks fine and then we could make
use of that year
so we have that
number of patches and then
we're gonna set our Delta so we have
Delta will take to be one now obviously
if we set data to be two it means you're
going to go from zero to number of
patches while it's keeping two steps and
that's not what we want so we we want a
number of patches or elements in this uh
embedded inputs so with this now we
could pass an embedding and where in
inputs and that should be fine okay so
we have this here everything looks fine
and we could take this off so now we
return we could return our output simply
now it should be noted that this
embedded layer is similar to the dance
layer but with a dense layer when you
have an input X you see with a dense
layer when you have an input uh let's
write it here for the dense layer we
have an input X
that input X is multiplied by the
weights and you add the bias so this is
how we get the output but with this
embedded layer is a simple matrix
multiplication so when you take an input
X you multiply it by the weights and you
get the output
with that now let's run this cell here
and then we move ahead so we have this
run and we could delete this two cells
now
now to test this out we could Define
patch Inc we have our patch encoder
patch encoder which we've just uh
created here so Apache encoder and the
sticks in the number of patches and
hidden size so let's specify those to 56
and 768 so we have this and then now we
could have patch encoder and then pass
in an image and see what we get as
output so here's image we have this
zeros there we go one by 256 by uh 256
by three so now when we pass an input
image we expect to get uh some output of
shape batch size by number of Patches by
the hidden size
all the number of hidden units and now
that we've built this year up to the
point where we have our embedded patches
let's go ahead and build this
Transformer encoder right here
as you could see without the layer
normalization Malta head attention and
then we add this this input to this
output we have a layer normalization
again then the multi-layer perceptron
and again we have this addition and then
we get the output
now to build the code for our
Transformer encoder we're gonna piss out
this patch encoder here we'll remove
this we have Transformer
oh there we go and then this Transformer
is made of a first Norm layer and then
the second Norm layer let's have this
layer layer Norm one is our first Norm
layer
layer normalization
lization there we go
that's fine
and then we have our second layer
normalization layer so we'll call this
layer num2
now we've defined our layer
normalization layers we could go ahead
to Define our multi-head attention layer
so here we have multi-hand
tension
and there we go
getting your multi-head attention you
could check out the documentation for
this so in documentation you have the
different different arguments which you
could pass in and the type of values
which the multi-head attention takes in
so here uh will specify number of heads
and the key Dimension here this Q
Dimension is the same as the hidden size
or the number of hidden units
which in our case we fix at
768. we could also have the value
Dimension drop out and disorder
arguments now what this takes in as you
would see here
is a query value key and attention Mass
which will not use here return attention
scores will not do this this training
will now specify this but oh what will
specify will be this query and this
value and then since we're not going to
specify the key it's going to consider
that the key is the or rather it's going
to consider that this value here is a
key so it will be the same value
that said gear would have the number of
heads let's take this off more to head
attention
number of heads and then we would also
need the hidden size oh yeah so before
we have the Hidden Side so we'll leave
that away here we place number of
Patches by a number of heads okay so we
have our multi head attention number of
heads hidden sides and then the next
will be the dense layers so as you saw
in this model here you see we have after
the multi attention we have layer Norm 2
and then we have this MLP which is made
of two dense layers
so we have ourself
dance one which is our dance layer and
then the number of
units here will take it to be hidden
size and then we'll specify the
activation to be a Jello activation as
specified in the paper so we have jelu
and then we repeat the same process for
the second dense layer so here we have
that and then stop
okay so that's it we we've specified the
two dance layers and we now get our
output so we should have that and then
now we could go ahead and call so let's
before going to that let's modify this
here transfer my encoder
that's fine
the name Transformer encoder
there we go that should be fine okay so
we we building our Transformer encoder
layer already and now we set to uh pass
this inputs into this different layers
uh we have our input here x
there we go we have X let's take this
off
and then X gets into the layer Norm one
so we have
um uh output x x equals layer Norm
one
which takes in this x here takes our
input X
and then I'll post this we could call
this in
and then we have this in
put
input we have our input which gets in
here and then produces an output X and
then from here we get into the
multi-head attention layer so we have X
again uh this is multi head attention
and this takes in X so now we have this
input which gets here it gives this
output this output gets into this uh
multi head and gives us output now that
we've had this remember from the paper
that we have this addition to do so we
have this add layer which we're going to
specify here because
um
after this output got into the
multi-head we got this output which now
needs to be added to this input from the
patches so we need to create this link
here so that said getting back to the
code we have our X now which is ADD and
this ad will take in this X
and the inputs
then from here again we take this and
pass into our layer Norm so now we'll
we'll call this let's let's call this X1
because we'll need this X1 again so we
can't just be working with x
uh you understand shortly why we need
this X1 so we have this and we have here
X1 okay so we have that
um and that's fine everything looks fine
then from here we take this and pass
I'll take this output X1 and pass
into our layer Norm 2 so we call this
layer num
two that's it and then this takes in our
X1 produces output X1 then from here we
take this and pass into our dense layers
so we have this
um X1 which is equal
or dense one and this takes in X1 and
again we have X1
which takes indents two
uh sorry which takes uh X1 which is
Garden from Dance 2 which takes in X1
and now let's say this produces an
output X2 remember this like our final
output so let's call this output well
let's let's call this uh output okay so
that's our output right there now let's
uh do this
then for this output again we're gonna
do this addition recall from the paper
you see uh after doing this addition you
get an output we get an output that we
take this output from here and add on to
this that's why you see we had to create
X1 for this and then X2 for this so
let's get back to our code we have that
and then here we have our output now
which is equal
um
add that's it and then it takes in our
output and this X1 here
or rather this X1 after this addition so
we need to have this as X2 so let's
change this to X2 so we could make use
of this now in this addition because if
we if we have this uh if we maintain
this to be X1 then the value we're
getting here would be this final
exponent we got here and that's not what
we want what we want is this output from
here so that's why we have to change
this variable name so we have X2 this
takes an X1 and then that's it so from
here now we take this output and add it
to this X1
there we go we have that X1 and we get
now our output
so we could close this up and that's
fine so we return our output and we have
our Transformer encoder right here
now we could go ahead and test this so
we have our Transformer encoder number
of heads uh hidden size that's fine and
then we also have this uh input right
here recall that the input or the
patches take this form so let's run this
and see what we get
oh we'll get an error uh from this yeah
this is logical because we need to pass
in at least two inputs so here if you
recall from the from this year from
multi-head attention you see this we
have this two which will be passed in
then this uh key is optional this one
optional and all this rest optional so
we must pass at least this two so that's
it let's get back and modify that so in
this uh multi-head attention we have
this and then we have X1 so that's fine
so now we have that let's run this again
and see what we get
you see that's fine you see we get
exactly what we expect so this is the
kind of input we get and here's our
output after going through the
Transformer encoder now although this
works make sure that you check your work
or check this code and be sure that
everything is working as it's supposed
to be so be sure that you pass in the
right inputs and get the right outputs
and so that you get the exact output you
ought to get and not
some up was different from what you what
you're supposed to have
um so that's it we have our Transformer
encoder and now we'll head on to
building our vit model so here would
have our vids model let's get back up
here
uh let's copy this the rest net from
your complete Network
we had this so just simply copy the same
structure
and then paste it out here now although
there's not much difference we'll just
the main difference here uh is that we
will have this model instead of layer so
here we have a model and then here we'll
call this Veet so yeah some of its model
our vision Transformer model
and then your we'll change this we have
the vision Transformer and we'll call
this our vision Transformer Vision
Transformer does it okay so there we go
we could take this off
take this off and all this of
then we're building such a way that it
takes in the number of heads the hidden
size
then from this patch encoder the number
of patches so we just need number of
heads hidden size and number of patches
so with that would specify number of
heads
there we go hidden size and then number
of patches
okay so we have that and then here would
have
a patch encoder which will be defined so
we have patch encoder and this patch
encoder which we have in right here is
simply what we created already so we
just have patch encoder and what does
this take so we get back here and we
look at this format see number of
patches and hidden size so that's why
it's important for you to test this as
you go on so since we've tested this we
showed that this works when you pass in
an input image so your patch encoder uh
number of heads and hidden sides
all right a number of patches and hidden
size so we have number of patches then
the hidden size which we will get from
here
now with we we have this patch encoder
we have our Transformer encoders recall
that we have several Transformers here
see we have L Transformer encoders so we
get back here and then we Define this
Transformer
uh let's call it trans encoders okay so
this Transformer encoders
will be a list made of different layers
and the length of this list will depend
on the number of layers so we have your
number of layers and then what we'll do
is we'll say for
underscore in this number of
layers or rather in range number of
layers
see we are then going to define the
Transformer encoder so we have
Transformer encoder so we have the
separate Transformer encoders and then
we'll specify a number of heads and
hidden size so here again we have number
of heads and then we have the hidden
size the input gets through this patch
encoder so here we have our patch
encoder that is this way we have X let's
call this input so here we have input
and this past passes through the patch
or patch
encoder and then produce the output X
then once we have this output x what we
are going to do is we're gonna Loop
through or we're going to go through
each and every Transformer encoder layer
so here we have for I in range
all self that number of layers number of
layers let's define this here
number of layers equal this number of
layers from here so set our number of
layers and then we take this in here so
now we we're gonna go through this and
then what we'll be doing is we'll be
having this x which is going to be
the output from this R Transformer
encoder layers so we have trans encoders
I which takes in
the different inputs X so we'll do this
for a number of layers times and then
for each of this we have trans encoders
as we've defined already here and we
pick the specific Transformer encoder
now once we get the output from here see
once we get our output from here we'll
now uh obtain an output which will
flatten so from here we would get we
will say x equal we flatten this out
take an X and then from this we'll have
this MLP block right here oh let's get
back here
oh
oh we have MLP block here okay so we
have this MLP block right here that's
after this now on the paper what they
had done was since they had this uh
class token they'll pick those last or
rather they picked this first output
here so this means that if we have let's
take from here if we have an output
batch size one let's take this off one
by 256 by 768 then out of this 256 here
or 257 because they'll have this
additional so out of this 257 will pick
out only one from here and so we'll be
left with that one which has
768 hidden units so basically this would
be like having a one by 768 output but
now since we're taking all this into
consideration we'll just flatten this
out and then pass this through our MLP
head right here so that's it let's get
back to the code we flatten this out and
then we we specify the dense layers
which make up the MLP head so we have
dance one
dense layer this dance layer has a
certain number of units let's say a
thousand oh let's let's give this dense
units here let's let's have it as this
argument so we have number of
dense units okay so we have a number of
dense units there uh let's specify this
number of dense units and then
we have the jello activation TF and and
gelu okay so we have that for dense one
and now we should have oh we should
write this code for dance2 so we have
now dense two and then here same number
of dance units you could always modify
this
and that's it
um next from here we have x equal
dance one that's it dance one this is
self
okay so here we have this one which
takes an X and then
uh dance two which takes an X now our
final this is our final output dense
layer has to consider the number of
classes so just as what we have been
doing so far in this course you would
let's take this one this complete block
here so so far what we've been doing is
we always ensure that our output
dense layer has uh the number of number
of classes number of units in this
output so year would simply copy this
scroll down back to our code and put
this right here
so that's it let's call this dance three
dance and that should be fine okay so
here we have
dance
take this off
that's fine we have that now let's run
this
should be fine let's go ahead and test
this so here we have our vit model and
we'll Define these because vit and the
parameters those arguments here number
of heads hidden size all of this we're
gonna Define this just down here scroll
down and then Define this here okay so
we have now this number of heads uh we
say eight heads hidden size 768 uh
number of patches
256 the number of layers let's say four
layers the number of dance units let's
say 1024. okay so there we go we have
our vids and then this vid now from the
we pass in this input to
1 by 256 by 256 by 3 and we should get
reasonable output we could print out the
summary so the summary and we could
check out this model
so you see here we have
283 million different parameters for vid
model now let's reduce this we could say
four heads just two layers and then this
number of dense units here could take
128. now let's run this again
and there we go you see the two layers
you see the patch encoder and then you
see the dense layers which follow this
uh Transformer encoder layers so now we
have this model
will change this to the batch size so we
have configuration
and then by size now the reason why
we're doing this is because when we're
training our buy size is going to be
known so we don't want to have this uh
here like that so with that now we run
this again
and run the summary
oh yeah we need to change this to 32 you
see when we change this it doesn't work
so here we have 32 same as our by size
that's it and now we can go ahead to
compile and train our model
our model on our training not that you
we wouldn't get the best results because
obviously the vids need very large data
sets or even extra large data sets to
perform as well as a confidence and so
when working with the vids generally we
want to train on a very very large data
set and then later on fine tune on a
smaller data set towards the end of the
ebook we still get this error and the
source of this error
is the fact that since we've fixed the
batch size that's uh if you get back up
here in our training if you see if you
look at this here we fix this and so
since this isn't Dynamic now we have our
data set which has been broken down into
batches of 32 and now towards the end
you may have a batch of say for example
eight
obviously because the data set the data
set isn't necessarily
divisible by 32 that is the number of
elements you have isn't necessarily
divisible by 32 and so you have a
remainder and so when you have this
remainder and then you fixed this year
you should get an error because now
you've told the model to always use your
at this position a value of 32 So to
avoid that instead of doing the patches
shape we're going to do tf.ship so with
tier the shape before we had patches we
got the shape and that was it but now we
instead using tf.ship so we call in the
ship method from tensorflow and then
your we're gonna pass in our patches so
once we have those uh once we have our
patches passed in we now select this uh
match Dimension and that should be it so
let's run this again
you'll see that uh even from here we
could modify this we could put 32 and
it'll still work fine okay let's say two
so with that now let's go ahead and
compile and then restart the training
the model is training and as you could
see it starts to stagnate around this
44.4 percent accuracy and
44.16 percent validation accuracy in the
next section we'll fine-tune of it which
has been trained on a very large data
set
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
going to be looking at how to fine-tune
an already trained Transformer more
precisely Vision Transformer model using
the hug and face library and tensorflow
2. hug and face today's at the Forefront
of practical AI and it permits
practitioners around the world to build
train and deploy state-of-the-art models
very easily it's also used by thousands
of organizations and teams around the
world
so here we have a host of different
tasks which we could solve with readily
available hogging face models like audio
classification image classification
object detection question answering
summarization text classification and
translation in our specific case we are
dealing with image classification
and if you click open right here you see
we have this uh image classification
page where you could already test an
image on this vit model here so this is
the wheat base model with patch size 16
and the image size 224.
we also have this Facebook's uh dit
based distilled model and with patch
size 16 image size 224. you could browse
a host of other image classification
models here as you can see here we have
the different models sorted in order of
uh number of downloads see 219
000 times this model was downloaded now
we'll be working with this Veet I'll be
fine-tuning this vid by Google right
here here we have the model description
so you could have that we've seen this
already in the paper
um the internet users and limitations
and then how to use this model without
any fine tuning so here you can pass in
your image and then
um already run classification on this
image using this Veet model right here
read for image classification model now
here you will notice that this is uh we
suppose that we dealing with a pytorch
model so we could check in the
documentation here where I would see
this V model on the left side together
with many other different models which
are available for free and you see here
we have this Veet you you could also
check out the d i t the distillation
Transformers let's get to D we should
have d i t around this there we go
here's the dit you see you have the dit
and this documentation right here so uh
we also have the swing which we've seen
we looked at the screen previously so we
could check out the swing somewhere here
um swing s Where We Are
swc you have the screen Transformer
right here so that's it see the screen
Transformer we have seen already now
let's get back to our vit
Vision Transformer okay so we have this
Vision Transformer right here and you
could uh here go through the the whole
documentation so we have the fit config
with feature extractor listen enlarge
this so it becomes clearer
there we go we have this feature
extractor David model read for masked
image modeling with for image
classification and you'll notice here we
have tfv model so the difference with
this is this is a pytouch
model and then this is a tensorflow
model which we'll be using now the the
tfv model and tfv4 image classification
now recall that you have your vid model
which starts from the patch you have the
patch once you have the patch you have
the Transformer encoder and then from
here you have you take this you have
this MLP head
and then you have your output right here
now with this uh tfv for image
classification we have all this full
year so we go from this patch right up
to the MLP head but with the TF vit
model
this part this part is not included so
what you get will be only those outputs
right here so with a TF vid model we
just we have this whereas with the TF uh
vid for image classification we have all
this now apart from tensorflow they also
have the code for Flex so you could
check out Flex vid model Flex vid for
image classification now that's set we
are now going to focus on fine tuning
this Vision Transformer model we'll
start by first installing this
Transformers library right here so we
have Pip install Transformers
now that is fine we move on let's go
ahead to start with the fine tuning but
then let's get back to documentation and
here we have the overview go check out
those wheat config right here and you'll
notice that all these different
configurations are basically what we've
seen already so we have this hidden size
768 as default value number of hidden
layers 12 so here the stacking 12
different
um
Transformer encoded blocks number of
attention heads 12 intermediate size
3072. now for this 3072
actually is for the dense layers we have
here now the input you're getting from
this normally or right from here we have
say one by 256 by
768. then this gets in and gets to this
point where we still have the same so up
to here is the same and we expect that
this output here should be of the same
shape but then in this MLP layer we have
two dense layers now the first dense
layer will convert this to 1 by 256
by 3072.
and then
the next Dent layer would convert this
to 1 by 256
by
um 768.
so that's why they call this the
intermediate
size right here so this in temperature
size you can see uh dimensionality of
the intermediate uh fit for a layer in
the Transformer encoder we have the
hidden activation JLo hidden drop out
probability so they have some drop out
your attention probably to drop out
attention props drop out probability uh
initialize our range uh layer Norm
Epsilon value
to better understand this we could get
back to the layer Norm documentation in
tensorflow you see Epsilon here by
default is 1 times 10 to the negative
three and then we could see uh where
exactly it's been used so recall that
with normalization we have x minus a
given mean divided by a standard
deviation
uh now we we do not want a situation
where this year is uh zero and then we
have an infinite output so we generally
add some Epsilon right here now this
Epsilon by default as you see here is
one uh
0.001 and in hug and face your it is 1
times 10 to the negative 12.
now it's only in quarters so there's no
encoder decoder that's why this is set
to False Image size 224 the size 16
number of channels three
what I'm gonna add a bias into
the query keys and values yeah true
encoder stride 16.
now you can remember the the use of the
stride when we're trying to get the
patches we once once we have an image
like this and then we have a price size
of 16 by 16 would move through 16 pixels
to obtain the next patch so that we have
no space here so uh we have something
like this actually
okay so that's it uh we understand this
with config you could check out your
this usage of the vidconfig so let's
copy this code and get back here
uh there we go get back here and then we
have this code pasted out here okay so
that's it you see clearly you could
easily create a wheat model without
necessarily going through all this uh
process which we had done right here so
this was just for educational purposes
it means that if you want to build your
own veit it's simple you just have to
um do this or specify the configuration
that's a bit config and then you
initialize the model and that's it so
let's let's run this and then
let's also uh print out this
configuration
let's look at that you see there we go
we could change this we could change
let's say we change this hidden size to
um some value
144. so here let's have our hidden size
so you see this is how you could change
the hidden size to suit your needs so
that's it you change this
that's fine you look at that and you see
you now have this new configuration and
that's it
now for the next we'll look at this uh
feature extractor the feature extractor
is similar to what we've done already
that is taken in the the input resizing
it and then carrying out some
normalization so that's it for the
feature extractor you could check in the
documentation the sweet model here is a
pytorch model so let's go to tfvit so uh
this is for tensorflow now so here you
see uh there we go we have our our tfv
model you can expand this parameters
and here we have all those different
arguments which we could check out now
here you have this example of how you
could use the tfv model directly without
um
going through any stressful process so
here you see we have this
um first of all we have the data data
set and then we have this image which is
extracted this you could you could get
this image from our own data set so
that's it and then you have this feature
extractor so that's a feature extractor
we have this uh model and now note that
here the tfv model is from pre-trained
so this means that we are going to use
this model which has already been
trained and you see the specifications
here with base patch 16 to 24
in 21k
okay so that's it
the inputs now pass through the feature
extractor before then pass through our
model so we'll see how to adapt this
code so that
we could fine tune our own model in
tensorflow
and as we have said before this tfv
model different from the image
classification model in that the outputs
here
and not the final output classes but
this hidden States from the 10 from the
Transformer encoder so let's scroll here
maybe that's really an example okay
there's an example here you see this
apple here that gives you directly a cat
so model print is one of 1000 image
classes so that's it whereas here we
have this hidden we have this hidden
States
okay we place this out here let's take
this off take this one off and then we
could get started with building our own
vid model based off this hugging face uh
tfv model so we wouldn't need this data
sets here we already have our own data
set uh that's fine we wouldn't make use
of this feature extractor we have this
model
uh yeah we have a hug and face let's
call this hug and face model and then
uh let's just take all this off actually
so we have this we have the organ face
model we have our tier vid model from
pre-trained and that's it
now we're gonna Define some inputs so we
have here our input uh is equal the
input layer and then we'll specify the
shape so here we we work with 224 by 224
by three and then using the tensorflow
functional API we'll get an output here
x which we take in this um hug and face
model let's call this base model so
taking the base model takes in inputs
let's call this let's change this to
base model
and so from here we have this base model
of V takes in the input and then now we
have the output here x now when we run
this you see we download this 330
megabytes uh pre-trained model let's
have this um our hug and face model here
so we we get the inputs from here and
then we have the outputs let's call this
output X
okay so we have that let's run this
again we have a hug and face model Now
set
and we'll still get this error you see
it's linked to the positioning of this
inputs here so let's let's change this
let's say we have three by 224 by 224 we
run this again
you should see now that everything works
fine see oh it now works fine so this
means that the inputs of this uh base
model here is a hogging phase model
should be of this shape so it's three uh
let's take this here instead of being
224 by 224 by 3. now it's gonna set
three by 224 by 2 24. now this means
that we need an extra layer which will
convert this into this before passing
into our base model right here so let's
build that extra layer and we'll take an
inspiration from our resize or skill
layer which we had built already let's
get to resize rescale
right you're
so we have that uh we'll modify the
resizer skill specifically for this um
organ phase model so here we have at
this code resize your skill
for hug and face okay so we have this
recital skill we'll resize make sure it
is uh 224 by 224 so every image which
passes here will be 224 by
to 24 we're gonna reskill and then after
we're scaling
we are going to permutate the value so
we call on this permit your permit layer
and the way we'll build this out the way
we'll call this pyramid layer will be
such that
we move this from this third position
this is zero one two three batch by 224
by 224 by three so we moved it from this
third position to this first position so
here we have three uh go into this
position and then this uh one two shifts
to the right so we have uh three this
one goes here three one and then this
two comes here such that the output now
will be batch the you see the batch
remains intact by uh three which has
been shifted by 224
by 2 24.
so be careful not to do instead two one
this is this is one two and not two one
because here we're having uh height by
width by channel so I want to change
this to channel by height by width okay
so that said uh we do this here so we
just do three one two and that's it so
after this input layer before getting
here we'll call this x we'll take in our
resize
rescale and that's it so this result
scale takes in the inputs and then here
what we're passing will be X let's run
this again and we should get an error
because
um
when we permutate it goes back to 224 by
224 by three so let's have this
see we have that 224 by 224 by 3 as we
used to working and then we run this now
and everything should be okay
oh we get an error it says it's not
defined uh let's run this or let's make
sure that's how we called it
uh let's go up resize oh wait we need to
run this actually
they should be fine now
um that's it you see everything is okay
so now what we'll do is we'll pass in
some inputs let's let's pass in some
input we have this test image right here
and then we have our model which takes
in the test image now we we need to also
convert this
or rather add the batch Dimension so
let's expand themes and take in the test
image right here
so we have that we run this and see what
we get
let's add this to the zeroed axis
axis zero run that again
and then we told that we expected this
but instead found this now uh let's get
back up here and we could change this to
by 256 and then knowing that this resize
will convert it back to 224 since our
model takes 224. so let's run this again
and there we go here's our output you
see we have the last hidden State 1 by
197 by 768.
and as we scroll we have this polar
output 1 by 768
and then from here we we scroll down
again let's see if we have another
output
and that's it okay so this is what we
get is output we have the uh the last
hidden State and this polar output
from the documentation where we have the
parameters TF with model the parameters
you see here we have this last hidden
State the polar output and then we told
that these are the two outputs we will
always get and then we told that this
one is optional the hidden States is
optional but the last hidden state is an
option I'll get we always get the last
hit instead we always get this polar
output and then this attentions here are
also optional so if you want to get this
attention so all you need to do here is
to specify config remember the
configuration config config
config.output attention set that to true
and so this means that by default this
will be set to false and then for the
hidden States
we also repeat the same so config that
output hidden States we set the two to
true
now here in the documentation they
explain the difference between this
polar output and this last hidden state
but uh getting back here you should see
the shape so you see this is
um
just one of this here while this is all
a full hidden state or a full last
hidden State one by 197 by 768 but this
model or this uh hugging face vid model
was built taken to consideration this
class embedding right here and so this
means that if you want to
um carry out some classification is
better off or were you better off taking
this final year this final
um all this
class embeddance Final hidden state
now if you want just those hidden States
we could specify this pick out the the
zero index we run this and we should get
only the output or the last hidden
States so that's it we get the slash
hidden States
and then since we are interested only in
that output
corresponding to the class embedding and
the class embellished at the zeroed
position here the zeroed position we are
going to take we are gonna we're gonna
do this here we're gonna take
um this we're gonna take for the First
Dimension here we take all
and then for this next one
we take we select the zeroth index and
then the next we take all so let's run
this again and see what we get
and that's it we have this output right
here
and now since we've converted this
hugging face model into a tensorflow
model we could do a summary
so let's run this and check out our
model summary so that's it we have this
model summary we scroll down see 86
million parameters we have the input uh
screenshot the sequential is corresponds
to the recession skill layer of it and
then
the slice in operator which we have here
which permits us get a specific output
now getting back here we'll now add our
final classifier so we have this and
then we have we'll call this output
um that's fine let's just call this
output so we have this output takes in
uh the dense layer as the number of
classes specified here and then we have
activation softmax as usual so that's it
we have this here output okay now let's
run this and see what we get
we get an error because we didn't pass
in this x here so let's run that again
now as the model is training just
remember that the learning rate we use
here isn't appropriate as we can't be
using this type of Higher Learning rate
when doing fine tuning so we have to
change this and use something lower
let's say 5 times 10 to the negative say
five okay so let's stop the training and
then restart this process you see now
that when we initialize our model and
then we modify this learning rate you
see the loss drops now much lower than
what we had before with a Higher
Learning rate and our accuracy is
already at 75 percent
and we are still at the first ebook
so be careful when you fine-tuning or
when you're updating all the parameters
of an already trained model you have to
make sure you use a very small learning
rate
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
going to log our data to 1db
in previous sessions we already saw how
to do 1db logs
that is logging our metrics like this
also log in this confision matrices
as we can see here we also looked at
hyper parameter tuning data set
versioning and model versioning in this
session we'll not just only log metrics
but also log tables like this just as we
had done before we are going to start
with this weights and biases
installation so we we have this pip
install 1db
that's fine and then we import 1db and
then from 1db Keras we import the 1db
Callback so we run this and then we go
ahead and log in
now we've we've gone through this
already in some previous sessions in
here you just have to click on this uh
authorize so you get your you should
have this link or this code to copy from
here now if you do not have this uh this
key if you don't see this key to copy
then you would have to sign up on the
weights and biases platform so let's get
back here we now paste this and then we
press enter
so that should be it now with with that
we initialize this project and we call
the project emotion detection entity
neural learn so we have that
and that should be fine so you could
change this to whatever name you want
and then uh whatever entity you
corresponds to to yours so that's it
currently logging as neural learn use
this to force free login okay so we have
that and then we have this configs here
so we run that
validation directory that's fine
now we go ahead and train our model and
we include this 1db callback right here
so all you need to do here is include
this 1db callback and training can start
now we just run this for say three
ebooks just do that for three epochs and
then let's just take a small part of our
data set so let's take the small part so
we have that and we run this
now as we train this model you'll notice
that with just a very small part of our
data set the Hogan phase model performs
quite well as you see we already have 77
percent of validation accuracy with just
this uh small part now the other point
is we get back to 1 DB you see here we
could check out on our profile
there we go you see projects you select
emotion detection
and then while those loads okay so we
have this and we click on this hopeful
plant right here this is what we
currently haven't this is our current
run so you see it shows us already this
uh charts here we have our top key
accuracy validation accuracy validation
loss and all of that just by specifying
that 1db call so this is already
information which is already been logged
in and as we know you could always get
access to this anytime
since this information is locked on
weights and biases servers from here we
see that the validation accuracy goes
right up to about
79.63 percent so it's about 80
validation accuracy while the accuracy
itself goes to
82.6 uh percent
and you could check this year you can
see it is 2.6 and then your 79.63 so
that's it uh we're able to lock this
data very easily the next uh callback
will be adding here will be that of
including confusion matrices so
here we put log
coefficient Matrix
okay so we have this log conversion
Matrix and now we'll go ahead and put
out a code for this note that for the
1db Callback we didn't necessarily need
to pass in any information here but with
this uh log conf Matrix since this is a
custom callback we're gonna
um
write code such that each and every time
uh we're done with the training we're
gonna
automatically generate this confusion
Matrix based off what the model predicts
now recall that we've already treated
confusion matrices so you could click on
this and then would copy out this code
uh copy out this part which permissions
get this predictions and the levels and
then we will not make use of this any
longer as 1 DB as a method which takes
in oil configuration Matrix matter which
takes in these predictions and these
levels and automatically produces the
coefficient Matrix so let's copy this
here and then let's get back to our
callback
there we go so at the end of each ebook
you see here we get the EPO clocks and
then we we go to the validation data set
and then we have our image the image is
passed through the model to get the
predictions and then we have the levels
obviously coming from this level right
here then from here we produce a simple
list of the predictions and the levels
so now once we have this list once we're
able to get this list which we've
treated already in some previous
sessions you now just have this part so
this you could check on the
documentation uh for this plots let's
get to the documentation the 1db
documentation you could check this out
here
let's type in confusion
metrics there we go we have conversion
Matrix uh 1 DB of that
let's check out this log plots right
here okay so here we here we in this
experiment tracking and log data with 1
DB log log median objects then log plots
okay so we have this with the ROC curves
or PR curves and our coefficient
matrices so we saw this already in some
previous sessions so you could get back
to looking at how to make use of those
1db so uh that's it you see we copy out
this piece of code here where we have
this coefficient Matrix we have or the
the ground truth that's the levels and
then we have what the model predicts
then we obviously have the class names
so that's it and then here you see Just
One DB log and then you specify uh this
uh string right here and then you pass
in The confision Matrix CM which is this
and that's basically what we are doing
here so just copy down that code so with
this here we have our white true preds
class names which is specified and then
we just run this so we run this and
that's fine now the the next thing we'll
do is we're going to create tables and
now we're going to see all how important
working with tables is as compared to
just simply logging uh values tables
will permit us visualize our data in a
more interactive Manner and here you see
under this data visualization you have
those log tables and we'll see how to
create a simple table and lock this so
here we have the ditter you notice that
we have different rows this Row one row
zero Row one two and three and there you
have the image and you have the
predicted and the truth levels so
basically what we're doing here is we're
taking this image
then we log so here's our image then we
log its predicted value let's say for
example class eight let's say pretty
class eight and then the truth level is
class zero then we take some other image
uh there's a pretty that is one and
here's one so basically this is what
we're doing we're creating now the
stable
where we have different roles and
different columns
okay so that's it we'll we'll see how to
create this and
we also see how to log this tables into
our 1db runs
so getting back to the code
here you see we have this different
columns image visited and label and then
we're going to call this table our
validation table we have those columns
which takes now columns here obviously
you could add this you could increase
this and put whatever values you want
there and then fill that so we have this
validation table which we've just
created and then now we're going to fill
the stable color of row by row so for
our first row you see we have the
predicted values uh our model takes in
the image that's it and we have the
levels and then here you see for a given
row we have 1 DB image we pass in our
image
that's it we pass in the predicted
scores then we pass in the labels course
to for corresponding to these three
columns right here and then uh for this
validator table that we created here
we're going to add this data so we're
gonna do this for each and every uh
element of our validation data set now
you would set it take a hundred and then
we'll get him back up what we'll do is
we are going to uh somehow unbatch this
so we're gonna change this batch uh size
to 1. because we we want to be able to
play around with a single validation
element and not uh say for example 32 of
them so because of that we'll just
change this to one and we run this again
uh this should be fine okay so so we
have this uh validation data that's fine
and then here
uh training okay we run this again and
that's it we have our validation there
now let's get back here as we said we
we're taking just a hundred of this so
take just a hundred let's let's even
reduce this let's say 25 okay so that
you could take all the elements actually
we just want to make this a bit faster
so we have that and once now you you
feel this you see this follow parameter
to fill each and every row so you just
keep filling rows in your table and
that's it you could get this uh here see
this we you see you have this table The
Columns and you have the data right here
and then you just log this information
so it's from this uh documentation you
could be able to uh understand exactly
how we build this table although it's
quite straightforward so from here we do
One DB log and then we have our model
results and we're passing the while
table so let's run this let's get back
here let's run this two cells
we run these two cells now and then we
start with the training so we have the
training now over and we could check out
those custom chat which is that of the
coefficient metrics you see here uh we
could get the number of uh times the
model predicted angry when we're
supposed to be angry here's the
prediction happy when you're supposed to
be happy then here is prediction sad
when it's supposed to be set so we see
here this is 357 times for happy 876
um for sat 682 and then here we have the
times when the model predicts add when
it's supposed to be angry so this is our
confusion Matrix uh which we generate
automatically using 1db conversion
Matrix method and then we move on to the
Stables so here you'll notice that the
Stables contain a hundred different
elements so or you could oh
keep going on to the next so we move on
to the next 10 and so on and so forth so
let's get back oh let's let's just work
with this now here you'll see that with
this table you can actually like here
you see if you scroll if you get get to
this hover on this and you have this
three dots click on that and you could
group so check on this see you Group by
image for this one what we have here is
this predictions you see happy the level
happy oh yeah sad sad angry angry and so
on and so forth so this model
predictions here are quite great now if
we increase this move you see
we have this example here where the
model or rather the true levels is happy
and the model predicts angry but when
you look at this photo it's uh it shows
that this person is not necessarily
happy so we understand why the model may
be thinking that this person is angry
and so with this 1db tool you see that
it becomes very easy to detect
mislevel images like this one now
another way to get this more
systematically is by getting your
but since we do not have the group we
need to start by ungrouping right here
so let's get back here
click on this we ungroup now we've
ungrouped already and then we get to
this level and then we Group by
those different levels you see that here
we have happy sad angry now
um this is what the model predicts the
model you see here the model predicts
mostly happy because obviously the level
is happy because we're grouped by happy
level you're sad you see mostly sad
angry and mostly angry now or what is
interesting to note here is for this
angry well the level is angry the model
never predicts happy
anyways let's uh get back here you
should be able to scroll through this
you see you should be able to uh scroll
through all the different happy images
and here you should be able now let's
let's uh
look at this you should be able to
detect cases where the model or rather
the data set has been misleveled like
here this person isn't necessarily happy
so already you could detect uh these
kinds of Mis uh classified or misleveled
uh little points
then we also have this image which is
almost completely blurred out you could
always you could check on those kinds of
images and uh take them off actually
because
if your model isn't going to be seeing
this in real life then it's preferable
to take this off nonetheless if in the
real world the model is going to be
meeting this kind of images then you
could allow this
uh
um let's keep going this way you could
also check out for those sad images
and be sure that this I actually saw
people
here again you see this person actually
smiling and it's labeled as sad
then for the angry you see this little
ball was visibly happy but inside level
angry so the 1db tables permits us
check this kinds of
errors in a very interactive manner
now we'll again ungroup so we ungroup
this and then we could take this R for
the Pretty State Group by uh predicted
levels so this is what the model sees so
the model producer this is Happy
uh this is sad and this image is uh
Angry you see what you notice here is
because this image you know recall this
image which we just saw because this
image has been had been labeled as angry
the model now predicts that this image
is an angry image which is not true and
so when you deploy this now into
production you will find that this kind
of images or this image will be printed
as angry whereas it's meant to be happy
and the worst part of it is that even
your evaluation wouldn't find this as an
error because already the level or the
the the class for this was set to be
angry
then another thing you could do here if
you get your
um
have this back another thing you could
do is
you get to this column settings here
click on this you could get to column
settings just by clicking on this column
settings this column settings click on
that and then your you select the levels
so here you see you're picking all the
levels
where the predicted value is different
from what the level uh
rather what the model predicts so here
we could say row predicted so when row
level is different from a rule predict
that we and that's it so we have that so
press enter
and then what we notice here is we have
this true this false and uh and that so
basically the reason why you have this
true
and this forces the true is for when
let's get back to this year
the truth is for when
the row level is different from the row
predicted so this is these are the wrong
predictions so what we could do here is
we could modify this to equal so that's
equal
oh that's fine this should be reset so
you see okay so you see now it's true
meaning that this false is when the the
prediction is not the same as the level
so that's it you could increase the size
of the stable let's get to this
increase the size
and basically that's it so you see uh
the greens are for when the coincide and
the rates are for when what the model
predicts is even from what the model
ought to have predicted now we could get
again to the stop and then check this
column settings then take this off so
you see you could simply take that off
okay so we have that reset again and you
now have your levels as you had
originally you could do the same for the
predicted now you could also get your
see this click on this and then you you
check the row row we're trying to get
all the rows where the row level is uh
different see different from the row see
type row predicted so that's it okay if
you say row level obviously you have no
rule so let's test that and you could
see you can apply you should have no
element in here see there's no element
oh that's not actually possible now
let's take this off and now we take raw
predicted so roll predicted and then you
apply
or you apply
no
um
some connectivity issues
so here we apply we check out where the
the the predict that is different from
the level so here we have this here see
happy and the predicted either sad or
angry so they are the wrong predictions
so with this you could check out and see
the kinds of images
which the model finds difficult or find
difficulties in uh correctly predicting
so like with this one you see happy this
the the level here is happy because this
man is unhappy this one doesn't look too
happy doesn't necessarily even look
happy this one is happy
and good look at that so generally for
this uh problem uh we see clearly that
many many problems come or many of these
misclassifications come already
from our data set so this means that the
data set we have to look at this set and
ensure that it is cleaned before making
use of it so you see this happy this
person isn't happy this this happy this
happy uh we could get to sat you see
this person is happy but this labeled as
sad so with this kind of uh interactive
visualizations we could be able to say
for example we want to see where the
model was also pretty uh a certain value
and it didn't produce that value now we
could also check out where this is equal
so we could check equals and say okay
where the the row level is equal to
predicted we apply and then we check out
the kinds of images we have you'll see
from here that uh most times the
leveling will be correct you see the
level happy level set the level angry uh
we are we still have this image here
this shows that we have even gone as far
as teaching the model to look at this
kind of image as an angry image
hi guys and welcome to this other
exciting session in which we are gonna
look at the Onyx format of representing
machine learning models Onyx actually
stands for open neural network Exchange
this open standard for machine learning
interoperability was co-developed by
Microsoft Facebook and AWS
and in the session we'll learn how to
convert our already trained tensorflow
model into this Onyx format and then
carry out inference on this are newly
created Onyx model so we've gotten to
this point where we've fine-tuned our
hugging phase based Vision Transformer
model
now we have this uh tensorflow model
which we've created and evaluated and it
may happen that
another developer using a different
framework like for example pytouch wants
to make use of this model which has been
trained in tensorflow
so thanks to the Onyx format we can now
convert this code which was written in
tensorflow or rather convert this model
which was built in tensorflow into an
onyx model and then later on convert
this uh model from the Onyx format into
pytouch
such that we now have this pie Touch
model
which this other practitioner can use
now another possibility is the reverse
that is we could go from the Spy Touch
model
to a tensorflow model
thanks to the Onyx formats
interoperability
another reason why a developer will want
to say take this model from pie torch
and make use of it saying Cafe for
example
maybe because that model is more
efficiently run in this other framework
and the reason why we have this kind of
differences for different Frameworks is
because for example you could have a
convolutional neural network or a
convolutional layer which is built in
pytorch with a certain implementation
and the implementation in Cafe may be
slightly different and maybe more
efficient as compared to that which was
done in pytorch
now this is just for demonstrative
purposes and we are not saying that uh
the implementations in Cafe are better
than those in pi torch
and so in summary the Onyx format allows
models to be represented in a common
format that can be executed across
different Hardware platforms using the
Onyx runtime so now developers can feel
free to build their models with just any
framework say for example tensorflow or
Pi torch or paddle or whatever framework
they actually want to work with knowing
that they could deploy your model on
whatever Hardware they want to since
they could now convert those models to
the Onyx format and then run inference
on this models via the Onyx runtime
which is in fact an inference engine
which is lightweight and modular and
permits us run our Onyx models on just
any hardware we choose to work with so
yeah let's look at the list of supported
Hardwares you see for example the tensor
RT which is very popular with the Nvidia
gpus and permit us to attain very high
speeds when carrying out inference on
neural network models the other good
advantage of working with the Onyx
models is the is with which we could
convert tensorflow models into this Onyx
format so right here you see we evaluate
in our model these are hug and face
model which we fine-tuned previously
and we getting 90 percent validation
accuracy
now we could go ahead and save this
model so yeah let's take this off HF
model let's call this hogging let's call
this vit
or fine-tuned okay so that's it we have
this Vine tuned or vid model which we're
going to save we check this out here
there we go we see a vid fine-tuned and
you could check you see you have the
saved model Keras metaditer uh variables
the assets folder and then here if you
you could see that this is almost one
gigabyte model so uh you could view this
here you see uh 984 just just check as I
uh over on this you see here
984.39 megabyte model
and so this means that if you were to
deploy this in a real world scenario
then you'll need to always allocate this
amount of space in order to run this
model
now let's move on to converting this
model into the Onyx format
we shall have this two installs so we
start by installing the tensorflow to
Onyx tool and then we'll install uh the
Onyx runtime so we'll run this
and then now we'll go ahead to convert
our model which is this one your vit
fine tuned so we just have to specify
your vid fine tuned into the Onyx format
so here we just say vit
fine tuned and then now we have this
model I'll give it oh this is the name
of our Onyx file so we'll call this vit
Onyx uh that's it with Onyx
um TF to onyx.convert and that should be
it so now we'll run this
then while waiting for that run to be
complete you could get to the Onyx
GitHub repo tensorflow Onyx and then
you'll have the documentation for
how to convert from tensorflow to Onyx
so let's get back to this
um still running
you can see we have a series of warnings
then uh specifies the tensorflow one uh
tensorflow Onyx and tensorflow to Onyx
versions then the offset then
um it's optimizing
and now we have this successful
conversion so on this model is saved as
vid onyx.onics now let's open this up
see with onyx.onics you see you you
we've moved from this
um let's open this again we've moved
from this year where we had uh
984.39 megabytes to this optimized Onyx
uh version which is at 327 megabytes now
another option will be to convert the
model from this Keras format to the Onyx
format so this first one we saved this
as a tensorflow saved model and then now
we could just have this here so let's
say we have the model we saved this
as a Keras model so we have the H5 and
we run that
um checking here
you see we have this still
984.98 megabytes close to one gigabytes
and then from this Keras format you're
gonna now convert this to Onyx
now here we're gonna have this
specification and then we'll pass in the
image size so here we have
um the batch by 256 by 26 by 3 it's flow
32 and is our input then we could
specify this output path so this one was
vid Onyx let's let's let's have this as
um let's let's call this uh vit
with
um Keras
dot Onyx okay so this is going to be our
output path here
and then we'll have
this tensorflow to Onyx your
which contains this from Keras method
which takes in our model again face
model
and then the specifications which we
just uh mentioned right here so here our
specifications right here we pass this
in this uh our passes as our input
signature we have this offset value and
then we also have our output path which
we have already uh specified here then
we have our output names which we shall
get automatically
so that's it let's run this while that's
running also note that you could check
out those conversions on the Onyx
runtime.ai platform where you can get
the details of all what we're doing
so let's get back here still still
running
and that's it complete let's check out
our vid Keras you see
327.59 megabytes
then from here we move on to the
inference where we'll see whether what
we get from the Onyx model coincides uh
with the initial Keras or tensorflow
formats so right here we have this
provider now here we specifying this
provider
to be this CPU execution provider as
we'll be running this on the CPU and
then we have this Onyx runtime
as RT which we are imported right here
and we should be making of making use of
here so the when we want to run an onyx
model you see the first thing you have
to notice we do not need tensorflow
anymore so even if we restart this
um whole process
all we need to do will be just to
install the Onyx runtime and then import
this this way so now we have our Onyx
run time we we have this inference
session which we create
by just specifying this path our output
path here
our output path is the path to this
model the Onyx model and then the
provider is this one here
so we just need to specify this path and
the provider and we're good to go so now
we have this
um the next thing we want to do is to
run the inference so the Onyx prediction
is this m that run
and then now we'll specify the output
names
now this output names is gotten from
here so let's run this let's print out
output names so you see what it contains
that's it you see we have that dense and
if we get back to
um when we're creating this model let's
get back to this okay you see the the
name here we have is dense so if you
specify the model name to be different
from this you would have a different
output name
so that's it let's get back to our Onyx
inference
uh We've converted already and that's it
so so that's it we have our output names
which we created all right I wish we
generated automatically from here does
it and then
um obviously it's at least because we
could have several outputs and then from
here we pass in our input image now this
is our input image is simply what we've
been having already so we just we could
copy this
copy this and then test this audio with
our Onyx model
um let's have this here add this code
pieces out
all we need here is just this basically
so we we could run this let's run this
that's it we have our image and then
let's run this and yes let's run this
and then we print out the Onyx print so
we get in input must be a list of
dictionaries or single numpy array so
what we're gonna do here is instead of
tensorflow we use numpy so you see
already that we do not really need
tensorflow like even with this we could
get the the test image from here let's
let's get this test image directly so we
could have test image and that's it we
run that we have our image that's not
defined
um
test image let's run that again
that's fine we get this other error
because this input isn't a float so here
instead of this we're gonna have test
image dot as type NP Dot float32
okay so we have that set now let's run
this again no before doing this let's
make sure we pass in this image instead
here so we have that we run that
that should be fine okay so let's rerun
this
again and you see we have now uh Onyx
spread so there we go you see it shows
us that it's a sad image because this is
angry happy sad so it's sad because the
sad has the highest probability and you
see the image here is sad now if we get
back to the stop here
and simply run this the same image let's
run this
let's get the probabilities actually so
let's let's say we want to have uh let's
print out
the model image let's get this
probabilities
you see this is what this model gives us
is output and here's what we get from
the Onyx model right here
now before we continue another thing
we'd like to check out is the speed or
the time or the latency of the model so
let's get back up here and we could
um add this could sell let's import time
oh we could just do it below so let's
um yeah let's do let's just do that
below so let's take this off and then
your
we could say we want to have less import
time
there we go and then
we have T1 which is time.time
and then we do HF model taking an input
image
then we record the time
the current time
minus the T1 so we could get the time
which is elapsed after running this uh
model you see 0.14
that's just 0.14 and you should note
that here we're supposing that we're
running this on a GPU so you check uh
manage sessions
we're running this on a GPU
now
for the Onyx model you could have here
T1 time that time and then we could
print out
the the difference in time so we have
that minus T1 let's run this and see
what we get
input lists a single numpy
oh let's run this again
okay so you see with uh we yeah we're
making use of the CPU and we're getting
0.279
seconds while with the GPU here we're
getting 0.143 seconds
now
we can be comparing the Onyx runtime
results we're on on the CPU with that of
this uh hungry phase model with
tensorflow on a GPU you could you could
even see from here if you do get device
you see from here that what the Onyx
runtime is using is the CPU and so if
you want to make use of the GPU we would
have to install Onyx runtime GPU version
so we could compare the the two
um
models
so for now just note that tensorflow
with the GPU is
0.15 0.15 seconds and then we'll need to
get tensorflow with a CPU
and then we'll also get
we we got Onyx with a CPU Onyx with a
CPU give uh let's say 0.3 seconds it
gave about 0.3 or let's run this again
if we run it again we should get
let's run this again
oh getting an error now that was because
I had moved this file into the the drive
so here we have the wheat Keras here and
we run this again we have about 0.38 to
see that's it about okay let's say 0.5
so let's let's say this is 0.5
uh here and then we need to get Onyx
with a GPU and then we also need to get
a tensorflow with the CPU so that's it
uh what we'll do now is we'll go ahead
and install the Onyx GPU
so here we have Pip install Onyx runtime
GPU
and that should be it we already
installed this okay so we have this um
Onyx runtime GPU and then if you if you
if you do uh import Onyx runtime as RT
and then you as RT and then you would
say RT dot get device
we are getting the CPU so what we'll do
now is we are going to uh restart this
runtime so basically restart this
runtime so that
um this the the GPU version of Onyx will
be taken into consideration
now this time around we're going to
install Onyx runtime with the GPU
and that's it as you can see now the
device we're using is a GPU
okay so we have that let's now get back
here
uh we already have our model our in the
Onyx format so we just run this
and then if you run this
you'll see that since we we will specify
the providers with the CPU
we shouldn't have any much difference
here so let's run this again import the
time output names not defined uh okay
our output names is basically this so
let's have this list and let's define
this here so let's have output names
um output names there we go
Apple names dense so let's run that
again that's fine and then uh we get
back here but note that this apple names
were generated from here so you could
um
get back to start generating this or you
could just make yourself the output
names as you can see since we restarted
this runtime we do not have those files
anymore apart from the Onyx uh we should
start in the drive so if we have to do
this we need to retrain our model
since we lost them already okay so we
have our Apple names here which was
specified and then we get back here we
run this again and check out on the time
it takes to run the model you see 0.34
not bad
uh 0.34 okay this is 0.34 so here
normally this should be zero point yeah
let's say 35 okay so the TF with GPU
0.15 Onyx with CPU 0.35 now the way
we're gonna use this is we will get here
you see
um in this documentation you have the
provider here we specify the coder
execution provider so let's copy this
and then
paste it out here so instead of instead
of here for example instead of CPU now
we have the GPU so we could make use of
the coder execution provider so here we
will take this off and then paste this
out so this is our provider now note
that since this providers uh can be a
list you could have several providers
like here when we do this what we have
could execution provider before the CPU
execution provider it means that
the priority goes to the Cuda execution
provider and so in the case where we are
having a CPU then we'll start with this
one and given that this cannot work in
the situation of a CPU will then move on
to this but if we have a GPU then
directly we will use this scooter
execution provider and that's it you see
0.048 seconds or let's say 0.5 seconds
which is three times less than what we
had when running our model or when
running the tensorflow model so you see
already that the Onyx uh framework
permits us to optimize our initial
tensorflow model so here we have Onyx
GPU now this is
0.05 so it takes us now 50 milliseconds
to run this hug and face model so that's
it
now before we proceed it's also
important to note that generally the way
we measure this time
it takes for the model to predict an
output we usually
can test with several input images or we
could repeat this process several times
so let's say for
um underscore in range let's say 10
we run this and then we get the time
elapsed instead of just testing once we
could test 10 times so we could get the
average so let's run that
and you see dividing this by 10 we have
0.035 so that's
um
35 milliseconds per
prediction
so this means that
for us to have a hundred
predictions
we would take 3.5 milliseconds we could
test that out let's run this
and there we go we take 2.3 seconds for
100 predictions now if we divide let's
let's see let's call this number of
predictions
uh we said this will be 100 and then the
time taken this is
uh time
for a single prediction
there we go time for a single prediction
all this
divided by the number of predictions so
we get the average
that's fine so let's run that again
so if you get this time
okay so we see 0.023
seconds that's 23 milliseconds
well if you repeat the same for the
hugging phase model
you see it takes uh 0.15 seconds
uh just as we had already
now we could see that the the the
difference in speed here 0.15 divided by
0.025
you see the Onyx model is six times
faster than the tensorflow model
now what if we get back and run the
tensorflow model on the CPU so change
this runtime known and we save that so
we have to rerun all this again
now running a hogging face model here
you see this takes 0.8 seconds 0.8 so
with the with the with the CPU
we have 0.8 divided by 0.35
the Onyx model runs about twice as fast
as a tensorflow model
hi guys and welcome to this new section
in which we are going to be looking at
quantization for neural networks in the
previous section we looked at the open
neural network exchange standard which
is an open standard for machine learning
interoperability we saw that not only
does this Onyx format parameters convert
models from one framework to another but
they also allow us optimize our models
for different Hardwares and so in line
with these optimizations we are going to
look at quantization which is a
technique for performing computations
and storing tensors at lower bit widths
than the usual floating points which we
have been working with so far in this
course
model quantization is a popular deep
learning optimization method in which
model data that is both the network
parameters and the activations are
converted from a floating Point
representation to a lower Precision
representation typically using 8-bit
integers now defining quantization in
this manner may not seem very clear so
let's try to understand
first of all why quantization or
quantizing a neural network model is
important so here let's consider this
very simplified model where we take in
some input multiplied by weight and add
the bias now we have several layers so
we just simply stack this up and we
could see we have our model which is
already been trained
and this model has a hundred million
parameters
and
occupies let's say one gigabyte of space
so we have this model 100 million
parameters one gigabyte of space
and if you're doubting what this space
is for
you should note that it's for storing
this weights and biases
and so obviously the more parameters
we're gonna have the
Behavior our final model file will be
now supposing you want to use this in
some setup like a mobile phone so you
want to use this in your mobile phone
it means that you will need to allocate
at least one gigabyte
of memory space if you want to run this
model
and this is where the techniques like
quantization come in
so now thanks to quantization instead of
storing these weights
in a 32-bit space we are going to store
them
in
8-bit memory space
so we're going from floating point
to int
it
now if you're not familiar with the
floating Point arithmetic
you could check out this resource by
Fabian sanglar where he explains
in a very intuitive manner the all
concept around floating points
binary representation
essentially if a single weight value
that's your model weight let's take this
off if you have a model with value which
is for example 3.14
the way this is represented in memory is
by first of all allocating this 32
spaces we have here where each space
takes a zero or one
at this first position here
the zero or the one is to specify
whether we're dealing with a positive or
A negative number and then for the next
eight positions
we are going to see whether this value
3.14 lies in the range
2 to the minus 1 to 2 to the zero or two
to the zero to two to the one or two to
the one to two to the two and so on and
so forth now in our case 3.14 lies in
this range
and given that this exponent we have
here is one we are going to apply this
formula where we have the exponent minus
127 should give us this um Power we have
here so we'll have that one so we have e
is equal now one hundred and twenty
eight and if you convert 128 to Binary
notation you would obtain this right
here
and now after encoding this
integer position The Next Step will be
to encode this decimal value right here
and that will be the role of this 23
other positions remember this is only
one box this is eight boxes and here we
have 23 boxes for this eight we've seen
that it helps us locate
uh number in this range which I've seen
already but for this other 23 boxes
we are going to suppose that
since we have 2 to the 23 possibilities
that's let's write this year 2 to the 23
possibilities
which is actually
8.388 million 608 possibilities so we
have
um 8 million possibilities here
this simply means that for every given
range which we have seen you for this
range this range this range this up to
the end we are going to divide it into 8
million different
parts and so if you see here you see you
have 2 to the power of one this is 2 to
the power of two if you break this Gap
if you break this here this here this
Gap into 8 million different parts
or better still if we consider that the
distance to move from 2 to 4 is 8.388
million then the finding this 3.14 or
encoding this 0.14 right here or let's
just say encoding 3.14 will until
calculating the distance from 2 right up
to 3.14 knowing that this distance from
2 to 4 is 8.388 million we can now
compute this Distance by simply doing
3.14 minus 2 that is 1.14
divided by all this um distance that's
two so we find this and then multiply by
the 8 million we have four seven eight
one five oh six so now
we shall convert this to Binary and we
obtain this year so once we obtain this
we then fill up all this 23 spaces right
here and that's essentially how a number
like this is stored in memory
and so getting back here if we have to
store this let's say 3.14
3.14 which was previously stored in this
32 box memory and now we want to start
in an eight box memory now we move from
one gigabyte to
256 megabytes here we have 256 and our
mobile phone will now need
only 256 megabytes of memory to run our
model now it doesn't just suffice to say
we are going to go from the floating
Point 32 to the int 8. we need to
describe exactly how this is done and
the way it's done is actually by a
simple linear mapping
where we shall start by defining two
ranges of values the first range is for
the floating Point values
and as you could see here the defined
negative a Max to Amax well
one good thing about deep learning
models is most times their weight or
your weight values lie between negative
one and one
and so getting back here we could have
here negative one so a Max will be one
and so negative a Max is negative one
and then a Max is one so we go from
negative one to one and then
if we want our output to be unsigned ins
instead of going from negative 128 to
127 we shall go from zero to
255.
now notice that the number of values we
have between 0 and 255 is the same as
number of values we have between
negative 128 and 127.
but with the unsigned ins all our values
are positives so instead of the int we
have unsigned int it
and so at this point our aim is to take
values ranging between negative one and
one and map them in the range 0 to 255.
and now we'll use a simple linear
function which has the form y equals to
A X plus b now our wire will be the
output value so we'll have the let's
call this x we'll call this x quantized
is equal x floating value so this is the
original value of the weight let's let's
put this in blue we have the original
value of the weight or the float value
divided by a certain scale
Plus
uh zero point value we'll call this Z
so simply 1 over s is equal A and B is
equal to Z then Y is xq and X is x f
so now our aim is to look for the value
of s and Z such that when we have any uh
value in this range we get its
corresponding value and this other range
the way we'll get S let's have this the
way we get s
is by doing X float Max X float Max you
see that X float Max is simply a Max
minus
X float mean
which is in this case negative a Max
divided by
um x quantized max
minus
x quantized mean
now if you replace all this by the
corresponding values we have here we
would have 1 minus negative one divided
by 255 minus zero
so 255 minus zero this means we have 2
divided by
255 that's our s which is our scale
and then Z are zero points is x q Max
minus x f Max divided by S this as we
just had here so if you replace again we
have X here Max which is 255 minus
um x f Max which is uh one so we have
255 minus 1 divided by 2 on 255 that
will give us 255 divided by two it's
essentially 127
27.5 so that's what you get now the way
you could look at this zero point is
is the quantized value we get when the
floating value is zero so when we
convert when we have zero here we have
zero on S which is zero
um the quantize is the quantized value
or the corresponding quantize values
equals z so that's why we call that the
zero point
and then s which is the scale simply
scales uh inputs your
as we go from this range of values to
this other range
now you could take a simple example
where you could leave from
um XF to X cure if you have negative one
here you see you have let's say x cured
is equal negative one that's XF let's
suppose we have negative one then
divided by S we said s was 250 2 on 255.
um plus z z is 255 divided by 2.
so this gives us zero which makes sense
as we go from negative one to negative
one one to zero to fifty five this means
that this here
uh this boundary values should be
almost the same
now let's take another example in the
middle let's say negative or let's say
0.3 so we could have X curl which is
0.3 divided by 2 on 255.
plus
um 255
divided by 2.
so in this case now
we have a value of 165
.75
which if we run up we could have
166 so essentially we're going from 0.3
to 166 and apart from around in the
output as we've just done we would also
see that we could
clip any outliers so in case we've
decided to have your Amax or our XF Max
to be one and that it happens that we
have a weight or weight value which is
more than this one
then the output
um unsigned int will be
255 so any value greater than this is
going to take this value any value less
than this is going to take this value of
0.
and so we've seen how this uh simple
technique permits us reduce our
memory used in storing the weights
now it's logical that we're gonna have a
drop in the accuracy because if you've
trained a model for example to have
certain floating or certain weights
which are actually floats and then you
convert these floats into integers where
you have some extra Transformations like
the rounded and the clipping then you'd
expect to have a drop in the performance
of the model nonetheless this huge gains
in terms of memory are
enough for us to sacrifice a bit of the
accuracy
or more generally the model's
performance and that said apart from
this model weight
size which is dropped or reduced it
should be noted that arithmetic
operations like multiplication and
addition of our quantized integers can
be carried out even much faster and so
we not only have a model which occupies
less space but a model which is even
much faster we have generally three ways
of carrying out quantization
the dynamic quantization
static quantization and the quantization
our training
now given that during the quantization
process the weights and the activations
are stored at lower bid widths
in the case of the dynamic quantization
this quantization parameters does a
skill and the zero point which we've
seen already for the activations are
completed dynamically or on the Fly
and because this year have to be
computed dynamically there is an
increase in the cost of inference so you
take a little bit more time to produce
an output as compared to other methods
like static quantization nonetheless
here we usually achieve higher accuracy
compared to the static quantization
methods for the steady quantization
method we first of all compute the
quantization parameters using a much
smaller data set which we'll call the
calibration data so essentially we have
our model and in here we have our
different quantization parameters but
instead of
um dynamically Computing these different
quantization parameters we are going to
pass in some inputs and outputs carry
out several runs such that we are able
to obtain the most unprepared
quantization parameters based based on
this data we've passed in and then now
when we want to run or carry out
inference we do not need again to
compute this parameters unlike with the
dynamic quantization where at inference
time we always have to
um compute this quantization parameters
here we compute this quantization
parameters before via our calibration
data and then now when we're running
inference we just pass in input and we
already have the quantization parameter
set
but the problem now with this method is
that if this calibration is done poorly
then we would have
um low quality values for the scale
under zero point and so because of this
we'll then have a lower accuracy as
compared to the dynamic quantization
method that said there's two methods
we've just seen are post quantization
methods so Dynamic and Statics post
quantization meaning that we train the
model uh first in floating Point 32 and
then after training the model we convert
this model to one with weights and
activations which are unsigned ins now
sometimes the post-training quantization
that is pretty Cure is not able to
achieve acceptable task accuracy this is
when you might consider using the
quantization aware training that
security the idea behind the
quantization aware training is simple
you can improve the accuracy of the
quantized models if you include the
quantization error in the training phase
so unlike uh post training quantization
where we train the model first before
quantizing your the network adapts to
the quantized weights and activations
during the training so as we were saying
we include a quantization error in the
training loss by inserting fake
quantization operations into the
training graph to simulate the
quantization of data and parameters
these operations are called fake that's
fake quantization because they quantized
data but they immediately decantize the
data so the operations compute remains
in float Point Precision that said the
post training quantization is more
popular than the quantization aware
Training Method
thanks to its Simplicity as it doesn't
involve the training pipeline the
quantization that we're training almost
always produces better accuracy and
sometimes this is the only acceptable
method and that's it for the section in
which we've looked at quantization of
neural network weights and activations
to help reduce model size and also speed
up computations
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
going to see how we'll move from a
tensorflow model which occupies one
gigabyte of space to an onyx quantized
model occupying just 83 megabytes at
this point we Now understand the concept
of quantization and we're gonna see how
to apply or Implement quantization
specifically dynamic quantization
to make use of our model even more
efficiently
before we move on we should also note
here that the TF size TF size is
um one gigabyte it's about approximately
one gigabyte
that's 1000 megabytes
while the Onyx size is 328 megabytes so
Onyx size
328 megabytes now we're going to look at
the Onyx
onyx
quantized let's just copy this so we
have the Onyx quantized CPU
Onyx quantized CPU
which we shall get shortly the
unexquantized GPU
and then we also get the Onyx quantized
size
so let's take this off for now and then
get back here now yes you could see
we've imported the Onyx Onyx runtime
quantization we've already imported the
Onyx runtime so here we just uh
importing this quantized Dynamic and
Quant type
then from here you see we have the two
models that's the floating point and the
quantized model now this year this model
is what we had already so we'll get back
and then copy that
and then we'll call this one the vid
quantized
so that's it now all we need to do is we
have this quantized Dynamic which takes
in this model takes in the quantize the
the path to the quantized model it's
still an onyx model and then the weight
type now here the suede type is
an unsigned int so let's run this and
see what we get we're getting an error
this name isn't defined okay we should
run this
before running this one
so that's it uh they should be fine this
time around and we should be able to get
this file right here this quantized Onyx
file
again here you could check out
documentation on quantizing onyx models
you see we have quantize Onyx model we
have an overview
and all of that so let's get back here
and check out our model
oh there we go we have our VidCon ties
and what we notice is we have 83
megabytes so this means that we've gone
from one gigabyte or 1000 megabyte to
just 83 megabytes
and now we could go ahead and check out
the speed or the CPU speed so let's get
back here or rather let's let's get back
here
uh
um there we go copy this path let's copy
this path and then we have this year
we paste that out here and then this
this one here this is encoder this this
is CPU
CPU execution provider that's fine
everything looks fine and let's run this
you see we get 0.39 that's particularly
0.4 seconds per prediction
and so here we have 0.4 seconds now
let's let's check this out again
um let's check this out again
for the original Onyx model so let's run
this
and check this out
you see here we have
0.49 that's particle is 0.5 so it means
that this isn't exactly true this should
be 0.5 so we we see that the quantize
model uh is faster
and way much lighter than the Onyx the
original Onyx and the tensorflow models
but we have to be careful as
quantization generally comes with a drop
in the accuracy now we switch to the GPU
and then test out our quantized model so
right here we have this quantized model
which we're gonna run
and then check out its latency
here's what we get 0.27 let's say 0.3
and this shows that the quantized model
doesn't benefit as much as the Onyx
model
from the usage of the gpus now if you
check out the documentation we'll see
that there's quantizing on onyx model
and this is a quantizing on a GPU so the
quantization on the GPU
isn't as straightforward as that with
the CPU
as here we told that we will need a
device that supports tensor core and a
computation like the T4 or the a 100
and let's see here that order Hardware
would not benefit from quantization
so if you want to proceed with
quantizing or quantization with a GPU
you can make use of this tensor RT
execution provider and here they give
the overall procedure to leverage this
uh tensor RT execution provider so with
that we're gonna get back here and the
next thing we shall do is ensure that
the quantization process hasn't led to
Too Much drop in accuracy as when we
quantize the model generally we may have
dropping accuracy but our Emir is to be
sure that this drop is minimal and so to
do this we are going to evaluate our
model so yeah basically we've defined
this accuracy which takes uh the model
and then for a hundred we'll take a
hundred elements 100 elements in a
validation data set
where the validation data set as a bite
size of one we are going to compare each
time the output or the Onyx prediction
with the level so here we compare the
level with the unexpedition and if they
are the same we increase the accuracy
variable value by one initially there
are zero total accuracy zero but the
total is always increased and then the
the accuracy is increased only when we
have this two the same so with this
basically we implement this accuracy uh
method which now we take the two models
that is the Onyx the original Onyx and
the quantized Onyx so here we have this
providers to to make this run faster so
we run this now you see here we have
ninety percent for the original and then
89 for the quantized model
the next thing we'll look at will be how
to visualize Onyx models using loots
Rodas Neutron app so you could get your
net channel app and you you have this
interface right here now we're going to
open the model
there we go it's loading
and here's what we get you see we start
with this transpose you could recall we
have this transpose and then we moved on
to this resizing then matrix
multiplication and then the rest of the
wheat model right here so here is the
vid model in this Onyx format on its
quantized format
scrolled right to the end uh right here
and then towards this end you see we
have this Matrix multiplications for a
linear layer and then we have this soft
Max you could also
um export as PNG
so you could open this up in this PNG
format right here so that's our model
and that's it for the section where
we've left from a one gigabyte model to
an 83 megabyte model with just a 0.01
drop in accuracy
hi there and welcome to this new and
exciting session in which we are going
to treat quantization our word training
with tensorflow
now in some previous sections we started
by explaining what quantization is all
about and the advantages of quantizing
models we also looked at different
quantization methods and we looked at
the relative advantages and
disadvantages of these different methods
that said we are going to see in the
section how to quantize a full model or
just some layers which make up that
model in tensorflow the special model
which permissions carry out quantization
is this TF mod which stands for tensor
flow model optimization and so here we
start by installing this tensorflow
model optimization model and then we'll
import this as TF mod then since one of
the quantization we could get in your
Keras and that's it here we have
different methods and classes let's get
into this quantize model right here as
you can see quantize a Keras model with
a default quantization implementation
and so here we have to Simply pass in
this to quantize argument which is the
model to be quantized and then we should
get a quantization aware model so here
for example you see this model defined
the sequential model and then we also
have this functional model then to
quantize this we just call this method
quantize model right here and then we
pass in our model and we have our
quantization aware model so that said
let's go ahead and implement this here
we have our model in this case let's
let's start with our hug and face model
so we have this our Hogan phase model
which we've declared already and now
let's say we want to have our Quant
aware
uh hog in face okay so we we want this
quantization aware hog and face model
and then we want to use TF mode Dot
quantize
model so basically let's copy this here
and then paste it out on the code
so we have that place it out and then
here we have our hug and face model so
from this we're running this should give
us our quantization our model now we're
getting an error quantizing a TF Keras
model inside another TF Keras model is
not supported so as of now this isn't
supported now
um let's try out with the efficient net
model though this should it should be
the same error because the efficient
model let's let's get up here
uh the definition for the efficient
model first of all you can see the hug
and face model you have this model in
this model so that's the reason why that
doesn't work and then we we get to the
efficient net model Transformer okay so
we have this model right here and we
could see that we have this Keras model
which is this backbone here in this
model and so if we were to use this we
have to look for a way to break this
backbone up into its different layers
but as of now what we've been doing is
just uh making use of this backbone as
you see here we just have this backbone
and that was it we didn't actually break
this model up into the different layers
now that said let's copy out this
efficient net model right here uh uh
we'll have to take all this off
and then now we are no longer making use
of this input right here
so wouldn't use this we'll use the the
backbones input directly so let's look
at that we have this x so from here we
have the backbones output which will get
into this global average pulling layer
so here we have backbone output that's
it we have this output which gets into
the global average pulling we have this
x here
that's it which now passes through this
dense layer
and then to the batch Norm layer
and then through this dense layer search
that we have an output right here
okay so we have that let's pass in this
x values
there we go and finally we have this
then from here now we create our model
so it's our pre-trained our pre-trained
model is a Keras model and which takes
inputs
the backbone input so now our our
backbone input is our input
and then our output
is simply this output right here so we
have that output okay so we have this
set now and everything should work fine
so let's run this here
and what do you notice you will notice
that uh the kiras model what we had
previously as our Keras model has now
been broken up as you could see
uh I think we should have just
um set a year pre-trained functional
model let's call this functional model
okay so let's let's go back and run this
other cellular
let's get back here
um pre-trained model
okay so let's run this again this is our
pre-train model
we could run this um summaries down here
and you could see Clara so you see here
we have this model is exactly the same
model we're dealing with so far this is
the exact same model uh what we want to
do is just to paste this to have the
pre-trained so this is a pre-trained
model
uh let's get a summary
between model Somali run that let's
reduce this so you could uh get into the
space
we have this and you'll see we still
have this exact same total parameters is
here the same number of parameters
number of non-trainable parameters
exactly the same so it's basically the
same thing but the difference here is we
do not have this
um let's open that up again we do not
have
pre-trained
summary
we do not have this Keras model here so
we do not have this uh model right here
and so uh because we don't have this now
it will be possible for us to make use
of this method and quantize our full
model
so that's it we have this pre-trained
model now let's run this again so we we
have this retrained pre-trained
functional model
search on that
okay
we have our model set and now what we
can do is we would run this now so let's
run this again and see what we get just
increase the size
and there we go we're getting another
error this uh the same error actually
let's get back here oh this should be
trained functional
so let's run this
now it's taking more time hopefully
everything should work well
now instead we get in this other error
yeah well we told that this rescaling is
not or this this layer here
is not supported
and this is normal since your industry
scaling layer we do not have any weights
and so we are not going to be carrying
our quantization for such layers so
um what we can do now is instead of
quantizing the whole model we'll select
some layers we want to quantize
so here there we go what we'll do is
instead select some layers so this means
that if we had let's Define a simple
model so let's let's uh get back to the
top
and then we Define for example this
limited model without this resize
rescale so that's it uh quite simple
model we have that now let's run this
let's run the cell and then
oops we're getting an error
so that's because we we took up the
recital skill and we did not specify
this year exact for an exact
um input size so let's run this again
that's fine now we have our Lunette
model let's do this the net model and
run that
we're getting under error let's check
that out this batch Norm uh is not
supported so you cannot quantize this by
storm layer so what we'll do is let's
let's basically remove the batch number
layers but later on we'll see how to
have to to to to quantize only uh some
layers so for now let's just remove this
batch Norm layers
off drop out let's take the drop out two
maximum off and that's it uh so we have
that let's run this again
uh let's see what we get
okay so that's fine you see now uh we've
been able to make this Lunette model
quantization aware and we've done this
for the whole or the full model now in
cases like this here this model here
those are efficient model where we have
this backbone which is uh are
pre-trained or backbone we cannot start
taking off the normalization layer for
example here and taking off this
rescaling which comes to the backbone
and so on and so forth so what we'll
instead do is we'll move layer by layer
and select the layers which we want to
actually uh make quantization aware so
that's basically what we'll do and so
instead of proceeding as we did here
with this little net that is uh
quantizing the whole the full model
we're gonna go layer by layer so with
that we could comment that section there
and now take this model of
now in order to quantize only some
layers of the model we'll make use of
this quantize annotate layer method
right here so we see again we have a
quantization Keras quantize annotate
layer and this takes in the model to
annotate with some quantization
configurations so here what they explain
is this function does not actually
quantize a layer it is mainly merely
used to specify that the layer should be
quantized so you see it's there to
specify that the layer should be
quantized and so the layer then gets
quantized accordingly when we do a
quantize apply so this is the quantize
apply method here
click open that and that should be it so
let's get back uh oh let's let's just
get let's just look at this example here
where you see this layer
you see we have this model but in this
model we want to quantize only this
layer and so as you can see we have
quantized annotate layer and then once
this is done we do a quantize apply to
get a quantization aware model which
here is called quantized Model so let's
go ahead and see how to implement this
with our pre-trained efficient net model
will now Define this method apply
quantization
to the count layers which takes in a
layer and then if that layer the name
all right here if if this conf
is in the layer name
we are going to
carry out the quantization so we're
going to apply the quantization on the
count layers
oh so here we have layer okay so in the
case where we don't have that we'll just
return the layer itself so the the layer
remains unchanged whereas conf layers
will become quantization aware so we
have this apply or metal right here
which will run there we go now once we
we have this method defined
will make use of this clone model matter
right here to create a new model but one
which takes into consideration a certain
clone function we get back here and then
we pay this out uh we wouldn't making
use of this in input tensors we just
make use of the Clone function and our
clone function here is this apply
quantization
to the count of layers
so that's it now you you check this year
if you check out here you'll see that
wherever we have the com flares you see
like this one we have this conf uh yeah
we have discount for the dev wise
convolutions and so on and so forth now
you could also include this for the
expand and reduce layers but let's just
work with only those comps so that's it
uh we you now understand how to pick out
certain layers or how to leave out
others from the quantization awareness
process so from here we we have this
apply right here and then we'll call
this our Quant our efficient net so
that's it we have this Quant our
efficient net and then we run this uh no
this model this model here has to be our
our pre-trained model so it's our
pre-trained model we run that again and
now this should be fine okay so we have
our quantize our model which is now
quantization aware and you notice that
when we do Quant aware efficient net
summary we should get something slightly
different from what we used to getting
um we have in this
uh now oh this is a no this should be
Funk so you should have Funk model
that's one that again
and run no let's run this
let's get back here and you see we have
this Quant aware efficient net and you
will not notice that let's get back to
the top
you'll notice that wherever we have this
uh conv layers see wherever we have the
conf layers we now instead have this
quantize annotate so as we scroll you
wouldn't see a comp layer but instead we
have the quantize annotates so that's it
uh years years because this didn't have
there's no conf in this name so we could
as we said before we could include this
SE expanding as it reduce
um layers so that's it we we now have
this quantized annotated layers which
wasn't what we had before making this
model quantization I wear or some layers
of this model or quantization aware so
with that now we are done with The
annotation and we're ready to make this
actually quantization aware so here we
call this one our model
um yeah there's a squant
aware let's get this exact name right
here Quant aware efficient okay so we
call that Quant aware efficient there we
go that's it and now we have our our
model let's run this again and then see
what we get as a summary
and that's it it's now quantization
aware so we know we no longer having the
the annotations but now some wrappers so
here you see the the layer name
but now we have this Quant which is
added to those layers
um let's scroll down check out on this
you see we have this other ones here and
so on and so forth so that's it we we
now have our quantization our where
model and we're now ready to compile
this model and train it like every
regular model
we get back to our training right here
and then at the level of this compile
we have your Quant aware model
that's it
um this this is the same linear rate so
that's it okay let's run this and then
here we also have our Quant
our
model
there we go so let's run this
we get in this resource exhausted error
so I'm going to restart the session and
hopefully everything should work fine
there we go we'll start the insertion
and now we able to train anyways we see
how to implement quantization aware
training with tensorflow and in the next
section we'll dive into post training
quantization
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
going to look at post training
quantization with tensorflow
in the previous session we looked at
quantization aware training still with
tensorflow
and now we'll look at how to do
quantization for a model which has
already been trained
now as you could see here we have this
pre-trained model which obtains an
accuracy of 84 percent and a top five
accuracy of or rather top two accuracy
of 95.6 percent
and then in the section we'll quantize
this model check out on whether this
quantized model
occupies less space as compared to the
original model and then also verify that
not much model performance is lost
before we start with the quantization
process we should note that we are going
to be using this tensorflow Lite library
now the tensorflow library is a mobile
library for deploying models on mobile
devices microcontrollers and other Edge
devices so this means that in this
environments where the compute resources
are limited it's important for us to
quantize the models since we will now
get smaller and lighter models and also
faster models here we have a general
overview of how this works you will see
you pick a model like for example
efficient net based model convert this
model to tensorflow Lite using
tensorflow lights converter which we're
going to see shortly we then deploy this
by uh taking a compressed version or
compressed TF light file now we're
already working with for example Keras
files which are
hdf5 files now this TF light is some
sort of compressed file and this
compressed file will be loaded in the
environment in which you'll be working
in and then from here we'll also
quantize this from 32 floats to 8 bit
integers which can run on devices with
low compute resources so you're in the
documentation we have your tf.light and
you have TF light converter basically
this tflight converter has uh the word
goes it's going to convert your models
into the TF light format and yes you can
see these examples you have uh the CF
light converter from a saved model from
a Keras model from a function from a GX
model so let's say for example we work
with the Keras model we just have the
model past year and then you generate
the CF light model from this model
making use of the CF light converter now
I'm apart from this arguments we also
have the attributes so here you could
specify the optimizations the
representative data set which is very
important in the case where we're
working with static quantization
remember that with study quantization we
have to obtain the skill and zero point
values by making use of unlabeled data
so basically as we had seen previously
all we need to do is to pass in the
inputs which in this case are images and
then this values will be inferred from
the model's interaction with the inputs
then we have the target specifications
inference input type inference output
type whether to allow custom operations
or not and then whether to exclude the
conversion method there or not so that's
it that's our converter right here now
we paste out this code from the
documentation
and then let's let's take this first
year now apply some of the attributes
that we have this converter dot
optimizations let's get back to the
documentation the optimizations and here
we could uh set this optimization
with this TF light optimize so let's
open this up
there we go
you see this takes different values we
have default what I want to optimize for
size this is duplicated does the same as
default optimize for latency does the
same as default uh experience this one
is experimental
hence subject to change so what we're
going to do here is simply take this
default so that said we have
um the TF
the light
TF the light
dot optimize and default just as we had
in the documentation right here
now we could also specify the inference
input type and the inference output type
so let's get back here we have
there we go converter
uh in France
input type is going to be unsigned int
or it and then
let's copy paste this we have the output
type which is going to be the same so
that's it so we'll specify this the
inference input type and the inference
output type and now let's
specify the representational data so
this representative data set right here
which in fact is a generator which
permits us output the input values
because recall we all we need in the
static quantization is just as inputs so
here we have the generator which uh
yields the inputs and then here we'll
just say converter dot representative
data set equals the representative data
generator
um here we have our training data set
now we could take we we could take all
our training data set or just a few
um
we obviously don't need to take all the
data set so we could just take like 20
and use that to obtain the values for
the scale and the zero point now if you
new to this notion of skill and zero
point it's important to check our
previous sessions where we treat this so
let's run this here we also run this and
now we set to convert oh this model here
is pre-trained our pre-trained model so
let's run that and that should be fine
so we now set to carry out the
conversion now we're done with the
conversion we're now going to save this
in the TF light format so we have this
path and this path we're going to have
this file so let's run the cell
and that's fine so we get that we have
the the the file size here and when we
check this up you see we have this 21
megabytes so we're going from
this model which we could check out here
we're going from this model which is
90.7 megabytes to a
21.12 megabyte model
now before moving on we should note that
if we want to implement Dynamic
quantization here then we wouldn't
specify this representative data
generator
so that's it uh let's get back
we install this
um
tensorflow Lite runtime now
um talking about installing the
tensorflow Lite runtime
once we already have this tensorflow
Lite file right here if we want to run
this in some other system say for
example want to run this in our
Raspberry Pi all we'll need to do now
will be to install this runtime and
that'll be it we wouldn't need to
install tensorflow any longer so we just
have this we run this that gets
installed we import the the TF light
runtime
then we prepare our test image so we
just run this we've seen this already we
have our pre-trained model we're going
to get the arc Max and then the
corresponding class so that's it uh we
should get angry see it matches with
what we expect
we could try out this other example here
let's run this and there we go so this
uh model now we're gonna use this
runtime to run our tensorflow Lite model
now we've restarted the session and
you'll see that without
tensorflow let's let's let's do this
let's say TF zeros and one by two for
example we run that and you see this is
not defined so we have no inputs for now
now let's take this off and then we get
back up here we install our runtime
impart the runtime
uh I think we'll be needing numpy so
what we'll do is we're going to take
this numpy
so we're trying we're trying to work
without necessarily needing tensorflow
so we have this imported as numpy
that's it
um here we have this test image
opencv so we will import uh CV2 that's
fine
uh well here we we make use of
tensorflow
but we will see how to get rid of this
dependence on tensorflow so first of all
here we have to note that tensorflow was
used here to convert this test image
here let's print out our test image
to convert this test image which is an
unsigned int with 8-bit so here let's do
this
you see it's on online
convert this into a float
and that's why we made this uh change
here so here we would wouldn't need this
any longer and here we could use numpy
so we have that and everything looks
fine okay so we we have this test image
and that's fine so now let's run this
and we have our image now image not
defined let's get back here uh no this
is the test image test
image run that again this should be fine
okay so we have now our image and then
here we see we have this interpreter
which loads our tensorflow Lite file
which we've saved in the drive and then
we allocate tensors once this is done we
move on to get the details the input and
output details which we had from the
conversion process now here here we have
uh the unsigned in and here we also have
done sign in and then you would see that
um we have this test image which we will
change the type so first of all you
notice that this image is 10 to a numpy
array which we don't need any longer
because it's already numpy and then even
this type we do not really need to do
this although if you print this let's
command the section and if you print
this input details and we get the data
type you will see that we have an
unsigned int now TF not
uh defined well here we use a TF light
so let's let's have this run that again
we have tflight runtime has no attribute
interpreter
now what we'll do is we'll have this dot
enter preter okay so we should have this
and this should work now okay that's it
now we have this we run this again and
that's fine so you see we have you see
the unsigned int which is what we
expected because when doing a conversion
we have specified that we wanted this uh
did it type for input and our output so
that's it let's take this off what we're
saying is we don't necessarily need this
step right here so uh this will have
been useful if we had this as a sense of
uh as a tensor in terms of the tensor
and if we do not have this as an
unsigned end already so now that we have
that you see we set the tensor so here
we have our test image uh that's it and
then the input details index you could
print this out so you see what's in here
input details index
as you could see it's zero though now in
this line we're getting an arrow
we got three but expected 4 for the
input so let's get back here
um oh okay here we here we had this
change to him let's have we actually
let's get back so what we're saying is
here we have this expand dims to get
from three dimensions to four dimensions
and the name was still uh in so let's
have that we run this again here we have
our test image now which has uh four
dimensions and then now this should work
so here we set the tensor and then we
run the inference so that's it we run
the inference here and once we run the
inference we should be able to get the
tensor uh
at the level of the output so let's take
this off and then run this now
takes a while yeah this this is the
inference uh process now you should be
noted that
tensorflow Lite has been built for
mobile and embedded CPUs so uh general
purpose CPUs like this collab CPUs
aren't the best match for tensorflow
Lite models in terms of speed now we
print out the output
oh okay just yeah let's print out the
output see what's what's in there see
there we go you show that we have this
here the highest value then we could do
NP dot Arc Max
of this
output right here
run that again that's it uh Now Let's do
let's take this here so we could get the
class name automatically then now let's
run this and we get the class happy so
this is what we expected
and again we've done this without having
to import tensorflow so we did not we
didn't need tensorflow once we already
had our TF Lite model
you could see here TF not defined
now our next step will be to measure the
accuracy of our tensorflow Lite
quantized model so here we do exactly
the same process as we had before we
basically have the model path and then
this input details output details and
then we go through our validation data
set take 100 elements now about this
until set so this means that we'll have
to
um import tensorflow for this process
since we are trying to evaluate the
model's performance so here we have this
we'll need the validation data set so
we'll need to get back and run this
cells here so let's get back here we
will run this
there we go we'll be running all the
cells
now I want to import this when
tensorflow is already imported we get in
this error so what we'll do is we'll
just have this here
we run that there we go and then when we
get to this accuracy you'll notice we
use but the tensorflow Lite so it's TF
dot light not uh TF light so we're using
this model from tensorflow and not from
this package which we had installed here
so that said now we have that Set uh
accuracy we have input output as we're
saying our validation data set
um test image which is going to be
passed here uh the inference we get the
output We compare if they're the same we
increase accuracy if not we Skip and
then we move on but to increase the
total and then from here we have
accuracy divided by total or let's let's
say positives uh divided by total or
let's say correct correct yeah correct
predictions so let's change this
to correct so here we have correct
predictions and that should be it so we
we have this accuracy here and then we
specify the model path let's get back
here and then take this path of our TF
light model now we we have simply
accuracy
accuracy and then we specify that path
um okay let's have this and we run this
now there we go we're done with
Computing the accuracy for our TF light
model and we get
0.82 that is 82 percent as compared to
the 84 percent with the original model
now to get the more accurate value for
this it's advisable to use the whole
data set so you could take this off
and so now you have your model which
performs at 82 percent accuracy and
which now could be deployed in some
mobile device
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
gonna look at apis Now API stands for
application programming interface
and in this section we're gonna look at
why we even need apis and also how they
work now supposing you've just built
this model right here let's call this a
model
M1 and this model can take in an input
and produce an output the question is
how do I make my web app like this one
or my mobile app or even my desktop app
access this model which have built such
that
a user of let's say this mobile app can
just by pressing a button get access to
this my model's predictions
the way we could go about this is by
making use of apis that's application
programming interfaces
as defined here on the g2.com website an
API
permits software development and
innovation
to be easier by allowing programs that
is for example your web apps to
communicate data and functions safely
and quickly
apis does application programming
interfaces accelerate Innovation because
more developers can build products based
on existing data and functionality
getting back to our example this means
that thousands of users now on the web
can get access to our model and
make predictions without this developers
of these web apps or mobile apps
necessarily
mastering the art of model creation to
even make these Concepts clearer let's
take this example so here we're
supposing that you get into a restaurant
you give a command to the waiter who
then takes this command and then tells
the cooks to make available the food you
have in the command then once this food
is ready it sends it back to the waiter
that's the API and then this waiter now
passes on this food to you or then eats
it and is happy now in the case of
computer software where we have say this
mobile app which has to communicate with
this API right here then this
communication has to follow certain
rules or protocol known as the http
this protocol guides the way information
is being transmitted via the web now
HTTP stands for hypertext transfer
protocol so this hyper text then
transfer protocol
now the type of data exchange could be
text could be images could be video
could be any kind of Theater which is
understandable by both this client right
here and the server also communication
following this HTTP protocol is
connectionless that is
each time this client needs to
communicate with the server to know what
objects are found in the particular
image a connection is created between
these two now once the connection is
created and then the client receives the
output that is the particular location
where the objects are found in an image
that connection is closed
and so we we now have this which is
taken off here
then once we want to connect again with
the API which is found on the server we
still create or recreate another
connection
then also as we have said the data
exchanger
isn't of a particular type so really
this protocol doesn't force you to pass
or receive a certain type of data so far
as the data you're passing or receiving
is understood by the particular entity
which is sending or receiving
then everything works just fine
then the last property of HTTP protocol
is it's actually stateless that is
once you make a request and then you
receive a response no client information
has been stored in this request response
cycle
hence once data has been passed to the
API and the response received you should
not expect to be able to retrieve this
data which was being passed to the
server from this point we are going to
go in depth into how HTTP works
so you get to this address
www.postman.com you could sign in or
sign up in case you do not have an
account with Postman now I have an
account so I'm just going to sign in you
get to this point here you see you have
workspaces my workspace and then you
have this link here which comes by
default you have this URL which is this
information you pass in each time you
want to gain access to a particular site
in this case it's
postmaneco.com now URL actually stands
for uniform resource locator and so this
address right here permits us
get access to certain resources which
are located somewhere in the web
and this brings us to the HTTP methods
if you click right here you'll see that
we have different options like if you
have you have the get you have the post
you have the put you have the patch and
so on and so forth
these are known as the HTTP method
and each time you want to get access to
a resource which is located somewhere in
the web you have to specify the exact
method so like with a get for example we
are saying that we want to get a
resource for the Post unlike the get
method where our main interest
is to retrive some data
here we submit an entity to the
specified resource
which often causes a change in state or
side effects at a level of the server
so this means that we could make use of
the get method when we want to retrieve
a user's information
and then we make use of the post when we
want to modify some data or add
information so like for example if you
want to get ready to start on a platform
then you make use of this post request
as we're gonna add a row on the database
so suppose we have this database right
here where we have the user's ID we have
the user's name and for example the
user's password so here we have this uh
small database and then we have ID let's
say ID 0 we have the name Fred and
password let's say whatever value we
have here now then we have id1 let's say
Sally
and then we have whatever password
you're then we could take two we have
Rita
and we have whatever name we want to
have here or other whatever password we
want to have here so this is it now with
the get request we could just retrieve
that uh Fred has an ID of zero his name
is Fred and the password is a given
password whereas with the post request
we could add a new user so that's why
they speak of constantly change in
states or side effects on the server so
we could actually add this new user by
passing information via this post
request so here we could add this third
I will add say mac uh let's say mac and
that's it so that's it for the Post
request now with the put request we
could update this data so this means
that here we could see uh we are not
interested in
um
maybe modifying the name but if you want
to update this password we could change
this password now to some new password
so now we could update this uh row right
here in the database now we could also
delete so we could just simply take this
off with our delete request
and that will be it for that row
we also have other methods like the head
the connect options
trace and Patch which you could check
out in this document right here
but most times we make use of the get
post put and delete
then also this responses have some
status codes which we have seen already
so you you maybe have seen a 200 uh for
okay so okay when you make a request and
it's okay you could receive that let's
let's make this request here uh URL
empty let's get back here and you see
you see here status let's highlight this
you see a stitches okay so this uh as we
have seen here let's get back
uh this has as we have seen here HTTP
response status codes so you could again
check in this documentation and have uh
every detail about the different status
codes and you need to understand how to
work with them as they're very important
when you're dealing with apis so here we
have informational responses successful
responses line between 200 and 299 and
that's why you see here we have this 200
uh status
code which is a success
and then we have redirections we have
planned error and we have several error
so if this error is coming from the
person sending the API request then
you'll be you'll be between 404.99 the
errors from the server will be between
500 and 5.99 so when the server is down
sometimes you'll see this 500 so you
could check here internal server error
the server is in color situation it does
not know how to handle so you can check
out all this in this documentation now
let's get back here and make this error
so let's let's put in whatever value one
year
write that again
and you should see here you see 404 not
found so you you get here you see 404
can't error so this error comes from the
client we are going to paste this out
here and then select the push request
get to the body
form theater this is the information
we'll be passing in so here we're gonna
have email teams and neural learn.ai the
password
not a pass word and then job neural
learns and then click on send
okay what do we get you see we have this
output right here we have our email the
username the job and the token status
200.
now you'll notice that unlike with the
get request we have now introduced this
body data so if we don't pass this body
data you see that we wouldn't have the
right output and this is because to log
in to just any platform obviously you
need to pass in your credentials which
in this case uh the email the password
and the job
so this tells us that when doing an API
call like this one so when trying to
make the client communicate with the
server we need to specify the HTTP
method we need to specify the URL
then we also need to specify the body
which in this case is all this
information right here that's the body
information
and the Header information
now this header and body information
could be broken up into the requests and
response so this is the request body and
here is a response body
and then here we have the request header
and the response header
which you can get by simply clicking on
this right here you can also check out a
list of HTTP headers on this
developer.mozilla.org platform right
here then at the level of this response
headers take note of this content type
which is Json Json actually stands for
JavaScript object notation which is a
very easy and lightweight format for
storing and transporting data from a
client to a server and vice versa the
Json format is programming language
independent and so if we have this
client
with code reading in JavaScript it can
communicate Json data to this API via
this request which is reading for
example in another programming language
like Python and then after processing
data the response and Json format will
still be understood by this JavaScript
client now to better understand the Json
formatting let's look at this output
which was generated after we made the
get request on this Postman Eco API
right here
you would first notice that it starts
and ends with those curly braces so we
start like this and we end this way and
then we have information stored in key
value pairs so we have the key and then
we have the value and then each key
value very separated by a comma so we
have the first key is here key
and then we have the colon and then we
have the value
we have a comma and then the next let's
say key one value one and then next we
have key two
value two
and then separated also by a comma from
the rest and so on and so forth so here
you see we have this is key one here key
one value one we have the comma and then
we have key two this headers key two
headers and then value two now value two
here is all this year so all this ditter
is our value two so all this it's our
value two and then we have a comma
just like here we had this comma and
then after we have key three and then
value three
now for a particular value we could also
have some sort of dictionary and so in
this case let's take all this off in
this case where we had this empty
dictionary this was quite simple but
here we have this dictionary filled with
its own key value pairs so here we have
this key and we have this value and then
this value is a dictionary made of its
own key value pairs see you have the
Commerce again and just like that so we
have the commas uh separating each and
every key value pair and then here you
just have this string so basically what
we have in here is we're having a key
which is a string
and we have a value which is some
variable now this variable can be a
dictionary like in this the first two
examples or it can be a string or it
could be an integer or even a Boolean
now if you check on this other request
here the push request you'll see this
same formatting so we have the curly
braces which open and close and then we
have each key and its value the key is
value key value and finally key value
now this was for the response so this
was the response body let's go ahead and
check at the request body request body
we had this form data but actually we
could have
raw Json data which is passed so instead
of using this like uh basically using
this GUI we could have this raw and then
pass in Json data so you see here it's
actually very easy to to write this out
let's have this here let's check back at
the form data we have email password and
job
um yeah we have the same so we have
email
there we go we specify the email
on neural learn.ai
and then we have the password
our password is
not a password so not a password there
we go next and final one we have the jar
we have here
near uh
learns okay so we have that so notice
how here we considering this raw data
which we're going to pass and then we're
going to see the output we get here so
let's send this and what do we get
here's where we get as output you see
here unsupported major type text
planning request so this means that the
request we sent uh was text type and not
the Json format so you'll notice here we
have text which was selected and we just
simply have to change this to Json so
changing this to Json
what do you notice is a change in color
that is because this now knows that
there are the keys which are in red and
the values in blue if it takes it back
to you see it turns back to all black
let's get back to Jason and then re-run
this so click on set on send
and let's see the output Json press
error
check that yeah let's take that off and
then send again
okay so you see now that once we correct
that and send this Json data we have
this output so basically using this form
data right here which you could now take
off let's take this off is the same as
as in this raw Json data so the role of
Postman is to make it easier for people
to test their apis using these kinds of
graphical user interface but you could
always actually do it by passing this
raw Json data as you can see here
and so now you have the stitches okay
whereas when we had this text let's send
so you could see the stages you see four
one five unsupported media type let's
get back to jizen and send and that's
what we have
you also notice again that level of the
headers we have this Json format so the
body the output we have here is Jason
data
then instead of passing this let's add
in some random stuff here and click on
send what do we have we have for not
found but we'll notice that the content
type that we have now is no longer a
Json but instead HTML and when you check
out the body you see we have this year
preview page not found this shows us
that we can have different content types
exchanged between the client and the
server
hello guys and welcome back in the
session we'll see how to build our own
apis using the fast API framework in
Python language previously we have seen
that we could wrap our deep learning
model or more precisely our object
detection model into an API and then let
this clients consume this API that is
allow them send requests like this and
then get responses
so yeah in Black we have the requests
and then now we have the responses in
red and all this is done using the HTTP
protocol and so now that we understand
the concept of an API and how this can
interact with millions of clients
everywhere in the world we are going to
move straight to building our own API
and to build our own API we are going to
make use of this python framework known
as fast API
now out of python based Frameworks
which can be used in building apis uh
Django and flask but in the recent years
the fast API framework has gained much
popularity amongst python developers
thanks to the fact that it comes with
some key features like its speed so it's
a high performance framework
time taken to code is reduced that's now
developers could now build Futures even
faster
with fast API you even have fewer bugs
it's more intuitive it's easy it's kind
of sharp robust and standards based so
because we need all these features while
building our object detection API we
kind of
have little or no choice but to turn to
the fast API framework and you're gonna
see how easy it is to create or build a
fast
highly performant and robust API very
easily using the fast API framework
first things first feel free to check
out this documentation and fast API
tangolo.com working with the fast API
documentation doesn't really feel like a
usual documentation as most of the
concepts are well explained and broken
down to enable just anybody with minimal
python knowledge understand and use fast
API efficiently so right here we have
the features fast API people you could
get straight into this tutorial here
user guide you see you have this well
written user guide you also have the
advanced guide so once you're done with
this user guide you could get to the
advanced user guide you have special
topics like concurrency deployment
project generation and all this and so
before we move on don't forget to start
the fast API GitHub reposit country one
of this car's prerequisites is having
used python at a very basic level and so
we're supposing that you've already
installed python without which you could
head onto python.org download and
install python based on your own
operating system so here you could see
we have python installed python version
check that out 2.7
and then Python 3
version we have 3.6 this should be 3.6
uh okay there's an error there we have
3.6 okay now the next step will be to
install fast API so we head back to the
documentation you have here this
installation all you need to do is
install fast API all you could do pip
install fast API all so you get other
optional dependencies and features or
start by installing fast API we have
piv3 install fast API there we go API
now installed we could do Python 3 and
then you import fast API
you could check out the version right
here we have fast API
and then we have the version
okay so that's it
0.78.0 so the next problem we may face
will be what if we have those project
this object detection project in which
we have the fast API version
0.73.0 for example in stock let's say
0.73.8 installed you have this other
project on optical character recognition
which needs a different version of fast
API that is
0.75.0 you'll find that with this there
will be a conflict as what we've
installed is this 0.7 8.0 version now
the way we could solve this is by making
use of virtual environments the way
virtual environments work is you could
have this project this object detection
YOLO X Project
have its own
isolated python environment with its own
interpreter where you can install this
libraries
in this python environment without it
affecting this other project which is uh
with another or which is built in
another virtual environment
where here we have a different set of
libraries and
Library versions installed so this means
that in this environment here we could
install a version of numpy say let's say
whatever version and then here again we
could install another version of numpy
which could even be the same as this
version but the difference now is in
this visual environment here we have a
version of fast API which is uh
070780 and and this sort of visual
environment we have this other version
which is 0750
and now this problem of conflict at the
level of the dependencies is resolved
now that we want to create a python
virtual environments we are going to
make use of this python model which is
the python Vamp model so here we'll
simply do apt install the python python
3 valve and that's it
so here yes okay and that should be
installed now we have the vamp installed
let's get into our neural learn projects
directory and then from here what we'll
do is we are going to create our virtual
environment we have Python 3 valve and
then let's call our virtual environment
venf emotion detection
the detection
there we go we should have this created
and from here you could do this and you
see that we have this van motion
detection you have created
let's get into this Vamp emotional
detection directory so let's do valve
emotion detection and there we go you
see we have been include leap leap64 by
Vamp and share now let's get into the
the bean so there we go we have been and
then you see we have this activate right
here now let's get out of this and then
let's do Source oh well let's get back
again another step so let's do Source
bin activate
and
we get in this error well let's get back
into valve emotions detection and then
let's reduce Source being activate and
there we go so one thing you could
notice now is the fact that previously
we have this root and this but now we
have this van before this so you see
that everything we're going to be doing
from now henceforth will be in the
context of this uh virtual environment
now let's do Python 3 there we go let's
import fast API you can see that we have
model not found so it's telling us that
fast API is not installed now let's get
let's exit and then
um deactivate the way we uh deactivate
it by simply typing and deactivate and
you will find I want to deactivate you
do not um have this any longer so we are
no more
um in the context of the virtual
environment so now let's do again Python
3 and then let's Port first API you will
find that here we have fast API
installed
you see we could also get the version
you see we have fast API installed but
in this virtual environment fast API
isn't installed
now let's exit and get back to our
virtual environment so we have sauce
Bean activate there we go and now let's
do keep install fast API so one thing
you could notice the fact that
out of the scope of this visual
environment we have this version of fast
API and now we could install another
even different version of The Fast API
so that's it we install fast API
another first API has been installed
like we could do that's in this virtual
environment we could do import uh let's
do item three and then let's import fast
API and there we go so we have fast API
now installed we could get this version
and you could see clearly that this
version is different from the other
version of fast API
another thing we could do is create our
virtual environment
with a specific version of python so
here we could have python 3.8 and then
we have a van
um let's say emotion or let's say emo
detection okay so there we go
um we run that and then we create this
new visual environment where the default
version of python is that of 3.8 now
let's again have this you see we have
this here Vamp email detection and then
we could get into that
emo
um detection and then let's activate
this
um there we go and see this right here
now when you do python you see that the
default version is this
3.8.13 so again here if you try to
import fast API you see model not found
let's exit and then keep install fast
API or and run that you'll get to see
now where this freeze that we have many
more dependencies installed because we
decided to do that so here you see we
have typing extensions starlets and file
uh pedantic which is very useful and
there's others now the next step will be
to install UV corn and uvicorn is an SG
server so sgr signifies asynchronous
server Gateway interface being a HTTP
server this UV corn right here is
responsible for taking requests from
different users so supposing we have
this three users right here they want to
get for example some predictions from a
model which is your in our first API
which we've bundled in this our fast API
code so what will go on here is this uh
user for example will make a request you
see to this server and then the server
gets the request interacts with fast API
obtains a response and then sends back
this response to this user now if you
want to connect with this web server
locally we could pass in this IP address
here which is that of the localhost and
then we specify a specific part such
that we now hear that the client sends
the request which contains the method
which could be for example let's say a
post method and then the best body and
headers such that once this web server
receives this it processes the
information and produces the required
responses we are now going to dive
straight away into some particles so
here you get this first API you have
this simple tutorial here which we are
going to follow and see how to easily
work with fast API right here we have
this which we're gonna copy
to open up the code with Visual Studio
we will get back and then we'll just
write code and there we go
so
um now let's actually
get out of this by user mode then we get
back in here
um
neural learn
there we go and then now let's just do
this again and you see we have uh um
Visual Studio which pops up we have our
neural and projects folder and we could
create this new file so here we have
main.py create this new file and then we
paste out that code now if you're
working with vs code it's recommended to
install this python extension so we just
go ahead and install this extensions see
we have that uh installing let's get
back to the code or let's just get back
to this so here for example let's unlike
this so it's clear here for example you
see we told to create environment.pr Y
and with this uh code we're gonna put in
there now to keep them simple we are
going to comment this region and then
also comment this right here so you're
not gonna make use of this we're going
to comment that and that should be fine
okay so we we just have this portion of
this part here now you see here we have
this app which is an instance of fast
API see we've imported this uh
from Fast API and then we have this
decorator here and we have this read
root method now this root method we
could actually change this so we could
say uh read neural learn root or
whatever or name you want to give it so
let's call that you know learn or let's
just keep it short let's just say read
so we have this read method takes a knot
in and then uh it returns this
dictionary or this jizon hello for the
key and world for the value do we have
this decorator right here where we
specify the method type recall we had
different method like the get the post
the put the delete and so on and so
forth so here for example we specify
this method so this is the get method
and so if we uh making use of this get
metal right here we have this path here
we have this path and then
this means that if our web server is
hosted on an address for example uh
let's say https
uh whatever
uh
whatever.com then this root path will
correspond to this part right here and
then if we want to do say a login then
we have your login this login path will
correspond to having this login right
here obviously uh would have a post so
change this to post and that's basically
how it works you see how easy it is for
us to create this kind of paths with
fast API and also specify your methods
uh very easily so here we have that and
we could have slash or or let's say a
whatever we want to have there and then
all we need to do here is to have this
here A now obviously we could have some
variables here and we're going to look
at that shortly with this other example
below anyways we we understand that we
want to get to an address
uh here whatever.com or let's let's even
say google.com let's say we're trying to
build google.com then we will just have
your this and that'll be it and so with
this now uh specifying this is going to
get into this method and return this
Json now to run this we'll just use what
we've been giving here in the
documentation let's copy this out and
simply paste this out here so here we're
going to open up the terminal to open up
this new terminal there we go clear
does it and we neural and project so
make sure that you're in the same uh
folder as where your main.py is found we
could do UV corn
and we run that errorless as the app
attribute app not founder model Main
so let's check this out
um let's save this
and then run this again there we go you
see now it works we have uh started
server process with your fabrication
startup application startup complete so
it waits and it's completed and now
uvicon running on this address on our
Local Host so what we could do here is
we simply control and we click open this
so control click and it opens up this
page right here there we go
the first thing we notice is this
message where we have meta not allowed
but why wish why would we have this
method no allowed message the reason why
we have this is because here let's open
this the reason why we have this is
because you're in the code
we actually use this wrong method see we
are supposed to use a get method instead
so we should change this and have this
get so let's save that again and then
we'll stop this and then run that again
click on this open this up and there we
go we have oh as we expected the Json
output here we have the ID or like the
key hello and the Value World now
another thing we could do is we could
get back here let's stop this see we
stop that and then let's do
um let's say entry point let's have that
and we save this so we we save this and
then we run this again
and then we click on this and you see
little not found so here because we do
not have this path we outputs uh not
found so let's let's do this let's say
entry points and run that and you should
have an answer
um let's check this out here we have
entry point and then your
we have entry point
um let's get back here
and then we should have this to resolve
this issue we have to put the slash
before the entry point so you have to be
very careful with the way you write this
now you save that again and then you
reload but aren't you tired of always
having to reload
I guess uh as myself you would also get
tired of doing this so let's do this
instead of having that we would add this
reload here search that once we save or
do modifications and save here
automatically our server is reloaded so
now we will run this
uh application style of started let's
click on that we have this and then we
do entry points that should be fine so
that's it we have hello world as we
expect now let's go ahead and update
this let's just say entry you see when
you save now you see here you see it's
uh shutting down waiting for application
shutdown application shutdown complete
finished server process starters have a
process with the fabrication of startup
an application startup completed so now
we have this uh which has been reloaded
so unlike previously where we will have
to stop and then start again now uh once
we make the modifications it's
automatically reloaded so let's get back
here
oh not here let's get back here oh no
yeah actually let's get back here
and then we are going to have uh let's
run this you see it doesn't work but
when we do entry it works now and we
didn't have to stop the server for that
the next thing we'll look at is another
interesting feature of fast API which is
the Swagger UI so here we've saved this
reloaded our server and then we get into
this and then instead of having that
we'll do docs so you see we have docs so
we have this page which pops up and
you'll notice that we didn't need to
specify that in our code so let's get
back here and what we see is we have
this uh method here and then we open
this up you see that's a path and then
we have the parameters there no
parameters so we have this simple get
request and then we have the response so
here the the code 200 I mean that's a
successful response and then the major
type Json and that's it so now let's go
ahead and try this out so you see when
we try that we click on try that out and
then this comes up we click on execute
and what we have is this output right
here so here you could see the response
body and then you could have the
response headers so that's it you could
also repeat this on the postman so we
have that you see the request URL
and then you have the curl
um this you could use also to make the
API calls so that's it we see how to
make use of these docs and now what
we'll do is we are going to uncomment
this two parts here so here we uncomment
this and then we'll uncomment this part
and then we save this and then you see
here we have this items now we will
notice that when we get back to our code
and then we refresh this we have this
automatically put out here so this means
that no matter the number of
different parts we create we can
automatically test them without any
extra effort thanks to this fast api's
Swagger UI so like here for example you
not only can test but you can also see
the documentation like yeah we told that
or this one item ID is an integer it's
required then this is a string cure a
query it is optional because here you
see it's not required and then you could
try this out so let's go ahead and try
that out we uh you see well let's cancel
and then you see you cannot do anything
here once you want to try out you could
put in an ID so let's let's not put
anything there let's just execute you
see we must put something so let's have
that 20 20 uh the string let's let's
leave that for now and execute so what
do we get as results is this output item
id 20 cure null now if we modify the
code right here so let's modify the code
and let's just see our item id save that
we get back here and then let's
um re-execute actually let's re-execute
uh what do we get you see it's all
automatically we have this modifications
and then now we could do this let's see
Hello we execute that and you see here
we have our optional string which has
been shown to us in this uh Json so we
had seen the Json format already here we
have the key we have the value the key
we have the value and so on and so forth
and then also we have the response
headers getting back to the
documentation you could see here let's
scroll back up uh no let's let's get
down you could open this up you see the
main the file the app the object created
inside of main.pi with the line I have
equal fast API reload make the server
restart I have to code change just only
do this for development so uh they're
saying that if you're in a production
setting that if you've deployed this as
you would see in the next sections where
you want to deploy this you don't want a
situation where you get to have this
reloads automatically
so from this now you see uh this
basically explain what we've said
already uh receives HTTP requests in
this path and in this order path so
we've seen this already now both packs
are get requests so we have the get
methods the paths this path has a
parameter Item ID that should be an ins
the solar path has an optional string
query cure so that's it and then yeah
you you you they get to talk about the
Swagger uh UI and then you also have
this alternative doc API docs here which
is redoc so basically what we'll do is
we just get here and then instead of
having all this let's say we have that
we just do redoc we run that and you
have this alternative uh UI here where
you could still again test those apis so
that's it uh you could test this very
easily you see we have that and then you
should be able to test this now you have
the response samples from here so for
this you have this response sample uh
you have the address
a successful response or the response is
unsuccessful where we have this photo
two now you could check out in the
Mozilla platform where you'll see the
exact meaning of this photo too so let's
let's check out
developer Mozilla 422 so you could
always get back to all this so you don't
have any issues understanding any uh
code you receive at output so here you
see unprocessable entity and that's it
uh that was it for this year we have
different responses that's fine the next
feature we'll be looking at will be that
of schemas what we'll do here is we'll
simply take this off keep it simple we
will not use this and then we'll change
this into a post request so we have this
post request right here which takes in a
body obviously we have a body and then
it Returns the elements in this body now
here we'll take this off and then we
have our post request so there we go we
have our post request is no more read
item but now add item now here we're
gonna have an item which is going to be
of type item so this is going to be a
special tie we're going to create now
here we are going to import py identic
or from from
identic we're gonna import the the base
model so that's what we're going to do
we're going to import this base model
from pyrantic and then we're gonna
create this item this class item which
is going to be a sub class
of this base model class right here so
we have this item and then we have base
model so that's it and then here we're
gonna say okay we want that and item
should have a name and a price so we
have name which is a string and we have
a price uh price let's let's say integer
let's say we our price an integer okay
so that's it so there we go or what
we're going to receive here is this item
of type item it's no longer the usual
types but now this special type item
which we've just created so now here we
have item
and then what we'll do is we're gonna
return this so let's call this item name
here so we have item dot name so we get
the item we return its name and then we
also have the items price so item price
and then we return the item dot price
okay so uh that looks fine let's save
this and
check our code here or check this API
let's refresh this and then here you see
we have our post we could check that out
uh let's try this out execute what do we
get we getting response body item string
item price zero now if we come here if
we get here you see a level of this name
and then we put
um let's say back and then price let's
say 20 and then here
we execute what do we get you see we
have back 20. if there's something you
can notice is the fact that this request
body here automatically takes this name
and price so uh let's get back to the
code you see that if we modify this
let's let's say we want to get the name
we want to get the price or let's say we
want to get the cost or let's say we
want to get a discount so let's say this
is discount on the item discount and
then let's put this int okay we save
that and then we get back here
we refresh this
um try that out and you see discount
automatically is here so the role of
this schemas is to provide a model which
the request body has to always follow so
this means that if you get back here
let's get back here and let's take one
of this off you see we take one of them
off we execute
check out the response you see here
expecting a property name and closing
double quotes uh all of that you see
here we have this unprocessable entity
error now this is because here at the
level of the request body we didn't
specify the discount which we've already
said in the schema that we need to
always have so doing this means that
each time anyone has to make a call on
this API on this end point right here
that person has to specify the name the
price and discount for the request body
now we could also enforce this kind of
measure at the level of the output so we
could specify a response body
response body and then we Define say
let's say let's say this is input item
let's call this input item and then here
would have output item so we want to
um create another schema here let's copy
this
and then the we're going to say that
okay we want those uh output to be the
price minus the discount so here we have
outputs
out
put and then instead of the price and
the discount we just want the selling
price so here we have selling price and
that would be an integer okay so we have
that now we have the output we have the
input and we have the output
um schemas uh they're both subclasses of
base model and then here what we'll do
is we'll say okay we want to have the
selling price we'll Define the selling
price to be the item
uh price minus the item discount okay so
we have that so we have this now and
then here we have the item name still
and then we have the item we have to be
careful the same as this so you have to
say
um selling price anyhow let's leave that
for now let's just say we have here
selling price so let's say we have
selling price and then let's save this
and check this out you see already post
got the last but uh an unexpected
keyword argument response body this is
actually a response model not a response
body so that's the output response model
let's uh let's let's change this to
input so now this input item for the
request and then this output for the
response now let's save this that's fine
um let's go ahead and check this out so
here we try this out there we go you see
as usual that's fine and then let's
let's give this a price let's say 20 and
no discount and then we execute so what
do we get here internal server error now
let's get back to our code and check out
what's going on here field required this
uh Missing now you see that uh
everything looks like normal but we saw
that there's a field that's required a
level of the output and the reason why
we have this is simply because this
output expects to see selling price you
see it expects to have certain price so
because we do not have selling price
here we're getting that error now let's
save this we get back here
I'll refresh that and then try this out
again execute no let's let's uh yeah 20.
anyway it should it should be the same
it's just that we want to have uh to see
the difference in the OR to see how the
selling price is computed here again we
have internal server error now oh this
looks funny let's get back and see where
we get an error we told field required
and it happens that we even uh do not
specify this correctly so here this
year's name price discount and this is
name so yeah we should also have name so
not item name we save that again uh we
go ahead and check this out here
uh
uh let's refresh that
try this out let's just say it's a cute
and that's fine so you see we have that
now and this is because we've uh put out
our outputs correctly so let's have your
say 200 and then
180 or let's say 20 and then we execute
that
um and see we have this output so that's
it we see how thanks to this schemas you
could now build apis which
permit the developer or whoever's making
use of your API to have to specify this
without which nothing is really going to
work so this means that you could have a
situation like here let's let's see we
have this input item and then we let's
let's save that again and get back here
we refresh this page
and then let's try out while taking off
this so we take this one off and then we
go ahead and we execute you see that the
output here 422 is a client's error so
this means that the client knows that
this error is coming from he's our side
now we get back here and then before we
move on we are going to Define this
structure or this code structure for our
fast uh API
um projects we'll be working with so
what we want to do is separate the apis
that's actually the end points from the
core now when we talk about core we're
talking about let's get back here we're
talking about carrying out computation
like this so you see this computation we
want to have some separate file which is
in charge of doing this uh in the case
of some deep learning model want to have
a separate file which will be in charge
of uh say taking the inputs loading the
inputs
um passing this input to a model doing
some post processing and then from there
now uh the up the the output from that
is as on to this uh endpoints because
here this one endpoint and this is
another endpoint so just like read this
add item now getting back here you see
this like having read here this one
endpoint read this on the endpoint at
item this may be an end point uh say
update item so like root you have get
items post items and so on and so forth
so now at the level of the core want to
have our business logic in our case for
this simple example our business logic
was basically just taking the the price
and then uh subtracting the discount so
that was our business logic but we we we
want to have this in a separate file now
uh for the schemas we won't also have
this in some separate files so we want
to have this kind of structure where we
have the car that's business logic
schemas and then we have the API in
charge of all the different endpoints
now to do that we're gonna create our
service so from here we have we're gonna
add a new folder which we'll call
service
and then in the service we're going to
add a new file which is no basically
let's copy this mean into the service
here so we could do this we could copy
that
uh move that
now let's stop the server okay we've
moved this into our service and then in
the service we have a new folder which
we'll call Api and then we'll create
another new folder which we'll call the
core now in this call we have a new
folder which we'll call the logic and we
also have another folder which is called
the schemas
schemas okay so we have this uh this no
this is this is this uh core has this
new folder which is called schemas and
not uh the logic so let's let's uh
delete this folder here let's delete
this uh move to trash okay so we have
that we have the car which has logic and
skimmers and then we have the the API
now which will have different endpoints
now given that we need to carry out our
inference making use of this quantized
Onyx model we are going to start by keep
installing uh Onyx runtime so here we
have Pip install Onyx runtime and there
we go
now we get in this error so you have to
make sure you run this as a super user
we now rerun this as a super user we
have Pip install on X runtime
that's now installed you see we could do
Python and then import Onyx run time
and that's fine okay uh that said let's
do peep install
opencv python
we could also check that out let's clear
this and Python and in part CV2 and
there we go so you see we have now the
Onyx runtime and opencv
um installed
we'll then move on to create the
endpoints so in this API we have this
new folder which we'll call end points
and then here we'll create new file
um which we'll call detects.py
and in here again we have another file
which we'll call
test.py now this detect.pyr will play
the role of actually
being that end points through which we
are going to carry out the detections
and then this one will be the endpoint
screw which will test if our API is
alive or not
now in Auto tech.py we are going to
import the API router so from first API
import API router there we go so
previously we had imported fast API but
this time around we'll be working with
this API router
then now we'll create this object
um emo router
um of the API router class where this
will play the role of raw information
from the detect.py to the main.py
now we have our emo router decorator and
then we have we specified I want to have
this get method and our path will be
detect okay so here's our path and then
now we could Define this detect method
in here with this detect method given
that we want to carry out detections
based on input images we're going to
have as input this time around this
image and then you would find that given
that it's an image uh it's going to be
of type upload file because the user
will have to upload this so that's the
time upload file we we have that we
could simply import this from here
upload file there we go and then once we
once we Define this we can now get into
the body of our method so from here we
could start by just um let's say we
output return
um return
uh say hello
hello world so let's just return this
so now we have this method which takes
in the image which is uploaded by the
user and then returns hello world now to
dive into what this detector is going to
be doing we'll need to import this um
image from peel so from Bill you're
going to import
image there we go so we have that
imported and then we are going to open
up the file so let's let's say we have
our image we want to get our image
um image
there we go
we open up
the file so we have image.open
the file which has been uploaded by the
user so we have in which is this
um dot file dot read
but this open method here takes in bytes
so we'll have your bytes
bytes IO so convert this to bytes form
and then you would simply import that so
we have from IO we import
um bytes IO that should be fine okay so
that's it we now have our image
which would then convert into a numpy
array so now we have image equal
um numpy array which takes in this image
and then now instead of returning this
we could have this method emotions
detector emotions detector which takes
in the image so it takes in this numpy
array or basically it takes no image and
then it's going to tell us what class
that image belongs to so for now we have
this let's import
um numpy that's important on pi so we
have
um
import numpy as NP okay so that's it we
now have this imported
we also going to check if the image or
whatever file we are uploading is
actually an image file so we get the the
the file name we have the file name and
then once we opt in the file name we try
to get this extension so right here
stick this off we have that um split
method then we obtain the extension and
if this is
um or as part of this that's if it's a
gpg JPEG or PNG then we know that this
is an image
and so we're simply going to pass
um if this is not the case then we'll
raise an exception
so here we have
um race race http
exception and then we will make sure we
import this
um HTTP exception
then we specify the status code AS 415
and our detail is not an image so that's
what we're gonna do before calling on
this emotions detector meta right here
now before we move on let's let's pip
install
um pillow because you could see here
that we have this
um
we have the pillow Library which is here
to be installed so we're just gonna do
here keep install pillow
there we go Wireless installing also
take note of the fact that this is meant
to be a post request and not a get
request so we'll replace this with post
now that we have Pillow installed you
see we do no longer have the warning we
had before so that's it now we could
um check out on our test.py
this time around we're gonna create this
tests
router so here we go we have a test
router and then we'll just call this
test
um testing and here take this off and
this is a get request so here we have
this get request and we would have this
test so this is our entry point
and then we could take all this off
um there we go
here we now have we're gonna return
um
testing oh let's see yeah testing
uh destined so that's it we have testing
testing
IPS working so this is what we're gonna
output when we
um have this all pass this through the
browser
now that we have this two endpoints
defined as this test and this detect
right here what we are going to do is we
are going to create in this API folder
the api.py file so let's create this new
file
api.py notice how this tool in this
endpoints so detect.1 py and the end
points folder or directory and then this
API the pys found in this API directory
so now in this API dot py what we're
gonna do is we're gonna create this main
router and the role of the main router
will be to include this detect router
and the test router which itself now
will be included in the main app
so as usual we have to import this API
router from Fast API and then once we
have this imported we're going to import
the detect router and the test router so
from service remember we've created this
already API endpoints detects our
detect.py right here we are going to
import
detect router and then let's copy this
paste out here now we're going to import
the test router from test
so there we go so we have the text and
the test router is now imported the next
thing to do will be to create our main
router we have this main router
um API router which we've imported
already and then now the main router is
going to include
um the detect router and it's also we're
going to include the test router so we
have main router including the detect
and the test router so there we go
again we can access the app via the
detect or test or maybe some other let's
say some Lambda Lambda router right here
and then all of this
get included in our main router which
now is also included in the app
back to our main.py we have from Fast
API this time around we're going to
import fast API
uh take that off and then now we import
the main router so we have service
API dot API
um import Main
router there we go so we have this main
router imported as usual we have the app
um fast API then we could specify the
project name
there we go emotions detection
and then we have
to include now our main router so this
time we're on our app now or with our
app we have the include router method
which takes in the main router so that's
it we have this
um now included and
will now turn all this into packages so
this endpoint we're going to create a
new file
um you need Dot py
there we go on the API API new file
we have init.py
then for the core we have under logic we
are going to create this new file
init.py schemas new file
you need the py on the core
oops car new file
you need Dot py
then finally for the service itself we
create this new file we have init.py so
we have our service package API package
and core package now remember we have
this emotions detector or meta right
here which we had to Define we are going
to get that defined in the logic so on
the logic we're going to create a new
file we'll call this Onyx in france.py
there we go and then here we'll simply
create this method
um emotions detector emotional detector
which takes in the image array
and then we're gonna follow up this
simple steps we had seen already from
the collab notebook we start by the
import then we specify the providers
then we there we go we have the
quantized model the image path the test
image which is created and then now we
finally run to obtain our predictions so
let's just copy all this out and then
put out in the code there we go let's
paste it out here
um yeah back here
there we go and then finally we have
those predictions
so that's it now let's make sure we
import Onyx runtime see Onyx import Onyx
runtime
Onyx run time and then also we will need
to import opencv and what do we need
again we need numpy so import numpy s NP
um there we go so yeah we import Onyx
runtime import opencv and then numpy now
this is our method which we're about to
Define
send this this way there we go and then
now we're gonna return this output
actually it's practically this year so
let's copy this from here
um let's copy this from here
and then paste out here
well so that's it we have this now let's
modify remember what we're getting here
will be the image re and so
um
we no longer need to specify this image
path let's take all this off take this
off and then from here we'll have this
uh quantized model
there we go we have our quantize model
we've already specified the the
providers so this quantize model for our
test image you see we're going to take
this image array
and then resize it so let's take this
off from here we have 256 by
256. we'll take all this off
and there we go
now import this Onyx runtime as RT so
they should be fine now
um that said let's get in here and see
what we have
um we print this out well let's just let
that for now and then we see we have our
predictions as we know already and then
from here we have the output now one
thing which is left out is this
um this file actually we yet to get or
put this file in this right position
we've copied this Onyx file here which
we trained already and then let's update
this then uh once it's fine let's get
back to our detect.py and make sure that
we import this image emotions detector
so here we have
from service
dot core dot logic dot
um Onyx inference we're going to import
uh emotions detector so that should be
fine we have now import this imported
let's check that out and then let's
let's save this uh get back to Onyx
inference and then now at this point
we're gonna say if
if um NP Arc Max
Onyx spread which is this here let's
copy this
and paste out here if this is equal zero
um then what we'll do is we're gonna
have
the emotion here this has emotion
um set to
um Angry happy or sad so here we have
emotion equal angry
oh yeah that's angry and then
um let's copy this well let's see
let's have this here
let's copy this here
this out here
now L if
I'll leave this is equal one
then this is happy
and
else the emotion
is sad
okay so that's it we have Angry happy or
sad and then what we're gonna return
here would be this dictionary where we
have emotion and then the output will be
simply the emotion so that's it let's
take this off now there we go we have
that set and when we get back to
detect.py you see that this fine we're
gonna pass the image and we're gonna get
the corresponding emotion now we have
all this set what we could simply do is
um run our server
before launching the server let's add
this root endpoint right here
and then now let's do let's launch the
server UV corn service main app reload
so that's what we have we get in this
error cannot import name detector detect
route from service API endpoints detect
Well what we'll do now is we're going to
create this new folder and we'll well
this shouldn't be in here this is going
to be here so in um neural land projects
we'll create this new folder
um new folder
which we'll call emotions detection and
then now we'll copy the service in our
motion detection folder
um let's move that there we go so now we
have an emotions detection we have the
service
we're going to relaunch the server again
you see we still get this error now
let's get into this
um detect file
you see here we have this you see
um it's actually emo router and now
detect router so if we get here we
should have Emo router
there we go email router and here we
have Emo router okay so
um we reload that we took another
important name test router well let's
get into tests
uh we have test router right here this
should be fine
now I'll get in this Arrow let's make
sure we have this here so we we created
this
um main router which is an object of API
router class receive that and then
um this should be fine this time around
so application startup complete
get into the localhost to see we get
what we expect we have hello world so
this is uh what we get when we uh pass
this in our browser
We Now open up the Swagger UI you see we
have this detect here as expected we
have testing and then we have the root
okay so that's it let's open up this
detect and you see we could try this out
then we could pick out a file which we
could actually test
so let's go ahead and test with this
file let's open this up and now let's
execute so let's check out the output
filter execute this and and so that's
what we're getting we're getting
um an arrow let's get back here
one thing you could see is the fact that
this you can request URL right here
isn't what we expect we expect to have a
slash before the detect so let's get
back to the code and then modify this so
take this off from here save this and
that should be fine so we should have
the same with tests
save that and yeah okay so that's fine
so let's now get back and then test this
out let's refresh
there we go we have detects we want to
try this out we want to choose a file
let's go ahead and pick a file this file
and then let's execute
okay so let's check this out we get an
internal server error let's get back
here and try to see where we have the
problem
so we've been told that this file
doesn't exist all we'll do is we make
sure that we put out the right path now
we have service
and there we go so we have this
efficient quantize.onics model which is
in our service directory you could find
service right here so that is it let's
um save this let's save this and then
let's go ahead and retest this so reset
um cancel try out and then let's retest
this once more
execute Simplex gonna work this time
around let's go ahead we still have an
error now let's get back to the code and
try to understand why we have this Arrow
we we told invalid rank for inputs input
got 3 expected four please fix either
the inputs or the model so this is what
we are getting here now
um let's get back again to our code we
told that what the model gets isn't um
what is expected so let's print out the
shape of this image array right here
Sprint out
um shape
uh
um image array ship and let's save this
and then try out run this again
um reset console try out and then
we test this once more this is a cute
dad
and obviously we have the internal
server error but now we want to see
exactly what gets into the model so
let's scroll
and uh
we should get the output okay so this
the output we get now you notice that
here we have this
um image which is of shape 90 by 90. but
what we would have respected here should
have been 90 by 90 by 3 so it's a
grayscale image when we expect an RGB
image now what we'll do is we'll see
here that if
um the shape is grayscale or rather if
the image is grayscale then we are gonna
make sure we modify that so if the
length of image array
uh shape is equal to
then what we'll do is we'll ensure that
we convert this from Gray to RGB so
let's do this uh let's scroll this way
let's do this and then let's print uh
what we have from here let's copy this
and then paste out here okay so uh there
we go we're gonna paste this again uh so
we see what we get after we convert the
gray to RGB so that's it let's save this
again
let's see if this this should be fine so
save that then we get back here okay so
let's test this again out
um reset cancel try out pick the image
execute and
there we go you see we have the emotion
happy right here so we have the expected
response so we have here emotion happy
now let's get back here and see see we
have 90 by 90. now it's 90 by 90 by
three after the conversion and then we
have after resize we now pass into the
model and we have the expected output so
that's it let's
um take this off
and that's it so there we go we've just
tested our API and we see that it works
just fine now you could take off
whatever prints we have here take this
off
take this off and there we go
then move on to our schemas where right
here we'll create this input.py and this
output.py file now in our output.py file
we'll start by importing base model then
we'll create this API output class which
inherits from base model and then we'll
specify
um what we want our output to look like
now given that we've seen already from
here our output is this string emotion
so let's get back to the code and see
that this is exactly what we want to
have so let's save this uh let's let's
say we put this as an INT and save this
then let's go ahead and test so let's
um well before doing an intestine we
have to make sure we integrate this with
the detect.py so let's get into this
here
endpoints detect that UI
um well you you have this response model
here but no only this isn't there so
before we did we didn't have this so we
have we should have this now you see
response model and I specify API output
so
um you are controlling what uh how this
output here should look like so now we
have that make sure you you import API
output from here and that should be it
so let's save now again and then let's
test this out so we execute and then we
check out the response you see we're
getting a response internal server error
which makes sense value is not a valid
integer so you see that we're able to
tell our API what we want our output to
look like now let's
um get back to our schemas let's take
down here output and then modify this
and say we want a string so let's save
that now and then go ahead and retest
this so there we go
um we execute and we check out the
response you see now we have exactly
what we expect so the that's the role of
the schemas now we're not going to do
the same for the inputs just
um we just do only for the output and
then and from here we'll move on to the
next part
then go ahead to measure out the time
taken by the model to produce the output
so we'll get into this Onyx inference.py
and then just before this well let's see
at this level once we obtain our image
we're gonna have time in it
time it needs which is going to be equal
time the time so we get a time this
initial time that's import time
right your import time there we go and
then once we import time and we have set
this time in it we want to get the time
elapsed so
um after we've gotten the prediction
when I get a Time elapsed you have time
elapsed which is simply the current time
minus that initial time
and then uh for the outputs we want to
have this emotion and also we want to
get the time elapsed so let's have this
well let's return emotion
and then we also want to return this
time elapsed
which is simply our time elapsed we'll
convert this into a string so we have
that now let's save this well this
should be time elapsed
let's save this and then now let's go
ahead and retest so right here we're
gonna
execute and see what we get we're
getting
um this output but we're gonna get in
this here so let's let's reduce this and
save this again let's get back here
let's save this again
um we run this execute
there we go we're still getting this
without the time elapsed
Well what we'll do now is we'll get back
to our schemas get back to the output
and then include this time elapsed and
it's a string so let's save that and
then kick back here
um there we go we are gonna execute
and we should get this response so you
see it takes about one second to produce
our output
now that we've seen that it takes us
about a second to produce the output
what if we loofah means to reduce this
time so let's get back into our code you
see we have the provider specified we
have the model from here and then we
pre-process the image and then pass the
model pass this input into the model and
then we'll obtain the output which is
um this now this model loading process
here we don't know exactly how much time
it takes so what we'll do is we are
going to include this time elapsed
loading so we have time elapsed that's a
total time elapsed for loading and
running now I want to also get the time
elapsed for just loading the model like
this so what we'll do is now we're going
to include this in the output we have
um time elapsed
loading
and then we have time elapsed loading
okay so we'll include this in the output
let's save that even output or py we
have this already so we have timer labs
and tablet apps loading let's save this
and then get back here
we execute
and let's check out the output okay so
you see here we have about 1.1 second
total time but the time for loading is
0.72 so this tells us clearly that a
huge portion of this time taken to
produce the output is wasted on the uh
model loading see this is about 66
percent of the time is for model loading
given that this is one this is 0.66 so
let's see how to load this model
um once we launch our API so instead of
um loading the model each and every time
we make an API call what if
um we take this off from here so instead
of having this here just take this off
we are going to put this in our main.py
um mean.py uh here we will have domain.p
we will have our model loading so we'll
import
Onyx runtime as RT
there we go then
um yeah now we we're going to load our
model
so we have our model now loaded here
we'll save that and then get it back
right here and then say okay every time
I want to make use of this we're going
to have this here we're gonna import
um
viewport service
dot mean as s so we have that service
with minus s and then you would have s
dot model quantized so we're taking this
from our main.pui from here so that is
it we save this now and uh we had we
still we took off let's take off this
time elapsed loading we don't need this
any longer because we we no longer load
the model well let's
um let's cut this from here and compute
the time it takes to pre-process this
image here so time elapse
free process take the off then let's
modify this here time elapsed
free process well let's Okay pre-process
so we have now this taken off
pre-process okay so let's get into the
schemas we have output time elapsed
um pre-process
save that then go ahead and run this
right here so let's execute once more
um
there we go we execute
and we check out the output you could
see here time elapsed now is
0.45 seconds which is
um about half or more than half
um of the time we were taken previously
so or less than half of the time we're
taking previously actually so here we
have the time and last for pre-processes
it's actually very small so all this was
uh almost of this was for the model to
compute the output so let's let's rerun
this again
let's execute that again C 0.49 seconds
now we've we understand how this works
let's
stop this run this again
and then check out the time when we just
um start our server
um execute and let's go ahead and check
the time okay so you see you have
0.41 second that's practically about 400
well 450 milliseconds so that's the time
it takes to produce the output now we
went we left from one second to now 0.45
seconds
one other good advantage of working with
the fast API and building your apis is
the fact that you could build
um asynchronous apis very easily and
it's just by simply specifying your this
a sync keyword so here we have a sync
save that
um test here async
there we go on the main we have
um async
and that should be it so that's all you
need to do to
um make your code as in Chronos and so
this means that when working with fast
API if we have this task for example
this one which takes much time to be
completed what goes on is this other
tests can be run asynchronously and so
while waiting for this tax for example
let's do it yeah while waiting for this
task we could already start working on
this other task and then while waiting
for this other types to be completed we
could also start working on some other
tasks this means that overall we have
taken up this time to complete these
three tasks whereas for synchronous code
we'll have to wait for each and every
tag to be completed before taking on the
next one so you see the the time
difference between these two different
methods we have here the difference we
see this difference here so this is a
gain in time when working with fast apis
asynchronous manner of running code
nonetheless it should be noted that
there are some tags which are compute
bound that's actually CPU bound meaning
that even if you have to run this code
asynchronously this first task will
still take up so much time so you would
end up with something like this so there
will be no real gain even though you had
to run this other test asynchronously
and this is very common in computer
vision and since we're dealing with
computer vision more specifically object
detection we have to understand that
even though our code is running
asynchronously
if at the level of this detector.py we
have this call on this emotions detector
and we're still waiting for that to be
completed no matter that we've already
completed this two tasks right here
we'll still have to wait for this to be
complete so for such CPU bound tasks
like computer vision machine learning
deep learning will instead take
advantage of parallelism with
parallelism instead of having one worker
one CPU worker to run all these
different tasks what we could do is we
could allocate say for example let's say
three workers so we have now three
workers where each worker can focus on a
given task and now we can now take
advantage of the fact that our code runs
asynchronously and takes or makes use of
parallelism now so far we've been using
this UV con HTTP server which pages and
asgi web server implementation for
python asgi actually means asynchronous
server Gateway interface which now
serves as a minimal low level server
interface for an async framework like
Fast API now although UV corn is coming
with speed it isn't mature enough to be
used in the production setting hence we
have to or we tend to use gunicon which
is a much of fully featured server and
process manager for our production
settings
so that's why UV corn includes a gunicon
worker class allowing you to run ASG
asgi applications with all of uvicorns
performance benefits while also giving
you gunicon's fully featured Process
Management so we are now gonna go ahead
and keep install gunicon gunicorn
once we have gunikan installed we'll go
ahead and run this command which we saw
already going on service main app and
then we specify a number of Walkers
let's change number Walkers to three for
example so let's say we want to have
three um Walkers and then our Walker
class is UV corn so let's run this and
as you can see we have this happening uh
occurring tries started several process
with a specific
um ID then we have your starter server
process with another ID another study
server process video so the ID indicates
in our three different Walkers now we
will go ahead here refresh this page
um try this out choose file
then execute and see there we go so we
have our output exactly as we expect so
that's it now you could obviously reduce
the number of Walkers if you reduce this
on to two oops reduce that to two you
would find that we have only this
process and this other process
so that is it
in the section we've just seen how to
build our own API and test it out
locally in the next section we are going
to deploy this on the cloud
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
going to deploy our API to the cloud now
in the previous session we have looked
at how to build this API using fast API
where we could simply pass in an image
like this and then obtain the output
where we we get the emotion that is
happy and we also get a time it takes to
produce this output so we could execute
that and you see we have our result
right here
that said the platform which I'll be
using to deploy our API is error code
and error code is a platform as a
service that surpass that enables
developers to build run and operate
applications entirely in the cloud so uh
first things first you could go ahead
and sign up so you click here sign up
and if you've already signed up you
could go ahead and log in so
once you've signed up and logged in
could get back to the code here will
stop this clear that out and then now
what we'll do is we'll do a peep freeze
so let's do pip freeze and you see that
we have this output which is basically
all the different packages we have in
our virtual environment so now
um let's write out I'll put out all this
um packages right here in a
requirements.txt file so we'll do pip
freeze and then we'll say wanna pass
send this to our
requirements.txt file now note that we
are in this directory emotions detection
it does this so when we do this here
you'll find this requirements let's take
this one off we did this previously
um move to trash okay so you find that
now we're left with service and we we
have this requirements.txt
that said let's open up this
requirements you see all the different
uh packages which we installed already
now would get into opencv uh we have
opencv well that should be python let's
search for opencv okay so it's opencv
Python and now what we'll do is we'll
modify this and the reason why we're
modifying this is because this version
of opencv right here is one which you
you could use even with a desktop
application but what we need for the
cloud is one which is headless that is
one which doesn't contain all the
functions it's really functions like
those of visualization given that what
we're doing with opencv here is
essentially
um maybe resizing and that's that's
basically it so uh we don't need this
opencv python
we instead gonna make use of this opencv
python headless so that's it we're gonna
um take this version 4.2.0.32
Theory two okay so with that done we
save this uh failed to save well
once you save that from Shredder the
next thing we'll do is we are going to
create this proc file so in here we have
well new file so call this proc file
there we go see uh recognize that
already and then what we'll do is we're
gonna paste out essentially what we run
um each time we want to launch our
server so we have web and that's it so
here because specify number of workers
to two and that's it so here we have
gunicon service main App Remote worker
set Walker class set and that's fine so
let's save this two and then we create
another file
runtime.txt now this runtime.txt is
essentially going to take this python
version so we'll copy this
and we paste that out here so here we
have Python and it should be fine now
also make sure you include this hyphen
before this python version
with our proc file ready the
requirements.txt file ready and the
runtime.txt file already we are going to
get into the error code platform where
we'll get right here and click on create
new app so we want to create a new app
and then we're going to give this app a
name so Wireless loads
there we go we're gonna call this
emotions detection
now you could either add this to a
pipeline or deploy this directly so we
want to deploy this directly we have
three options using the arrow cool git
using uh by connecting to GitHub or
using the error code CLI so we want to
use error code gits and so we're going
to follow this simple instructions right
here so it's not very long now first
things first error code login so
um let's get back here we have error
code login
now you'll find that this will work and
now but you should know that let's let's
stop this you should note that
um if you don't have um error code
initially installed this wouldn't work
so the first thing you want to do is do
a sudo snap install Arrow cool sudo snap
install aroku before doing the error
code login now given that I've done that
already I'll just do a Roku login and
then that should be fine so right here
we have a Roku login pressing a key to
open up the browser pressing the key and
you should be able to log in very easily
there we go you click on this link right
here and if you click on that link you
should be able to log in so you could
see here we have logged in so that is it
we now log in the next thing we want to
do is
um from here what we want to do now is
get into our project directory so once
again to our directory let's Zoom this
we get to our project directory and then
from there we do a git init now if
you're not familiar with Git You could
take a crash course and git so you get
familiar with all these terms so let's
get back here and do let's clear this
um clear
and then we do a git init
there we go see we in this emotional
detection directory now once we've done
that you see initialize empty gear
repository in our directory now the next
thing we want to do is
um have this here let's copy this and
then
um paste this out here so we have this
error code git remote and then we
specify the project name notice how this
project name is automatically generated
because this is what we put in
um let's get back here run this and that
should be fine
so that's what we have now on command
field we told that to well we command
field get remote fatal
um unsafe repository to add an exception
for this directory called git config and
uh that's it so what we'll do is now
we're gonna
copy this and then paste out right here
so
there we go let's now get back and run
this and this should work so that is it
so set git remote
um Arrow cool to this and that's fine
now the next step we want to do is um
deploy the application so we have git
add git commit and git push so let's go
ahead do git add we want to add up all
uh files so pick the dot and then we
have let's copy this git commit
um git commit make it better
place it out well let's say our first
um
commit off
uh emotions
detection app or well API so this is a
string which you could obviously modify
now we run that and then now oh you see
we have all this
um created and then now let's go ahead
and do the git push Aero cool master so
here we have
git push Arrow cool master and they
should work fine
what we get here is this push rejected
to emotions detection neural learn so
let's scroll up and try to understand
why we have this problem so we told your
request that um runtime is now available
for this stack let's open this up
and then
um let's try to check out on those
different
python versions available for the stack
here you could see we have this
um
3.9.15 which is on all supported Stacks
so let's get back here and then
um a level of the runtime let's let's
take all this off paste that now save
that
save that and then we'll do
um get add
yeah
um get commit now what we'll say here is
we have uh
updated
runtime.txt file with
um python version 3
.9.15 from that and then now we're ready
to do git push error code master once
more
we still get another arrow right here
where we told that no matching
distribution found for opencv python
headless
so now we're going to take off this
version and then we do the git push one
more time
once I get pushed down you see that we
now have this release and here's our
link so let's click on this we open up
and there we go see we have hello world
so this is what we have online now and
we could go
um Docs
and we check out on our Swagger UI so
let's reduce this and
let's try this out so you will Trend
this out online we've deployed this on
the cloud let's execute and see what we
get okay so it even takes less time as
compared to with uh the PCS they can
like uh 0.23 seconds that's about 230
milliseconds let's reduce this so you
could see that
um okay so that's it so we see that our
model is working we're able to obtain
our outputs and then now what we could
do is we we could actually from here
let's copy this here
and then try this out on Postman so
there we go we have this enter the URL
and then we select post request
um well here we have the body
here we have form data then our key our
key here is going to be image in and
then the value given that it's a file we
will now select the file there we go we
have our file selected click on send and
we should get our expected output you
see here we have
happy and time elapsed 230 milliseconds
so that's what we expect you could see
from here we have this different timing
we have the studios and we have
the time it took for all the different
events right here
and so that's it for the section in
which we've deployed our API to the
cloud and the next section we are going
to carry out load testing on our
deployed API
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
going to be looking at load testing the
low testing tool we'll be using will be
Locust and lockers will permit us not
only Define user Behavior with python
code but also swarm our system or API
which we've built already with millions
of simultaneous users so in those cars
we'll see how to test or better still to
load test the API we've built previously
both locally and on the cloud at this
point you've already tested the model uh
which has been deployed on error cool
and everything looks fine but then what
if we tell you that we will have to
still carry out some load testing now
what's the point of load testing the
point of load testing here is to see how
this
um your API which you build will react
when you have many users so you wouldn't
uh generally want to create apis to be
used by yourself only but maybe to be
used by tens of thousands and even
millions of different simultaneous users
so we cannot uh get access to this
millions of people so you wouldn't start
calling each and every one of those
people here to test your API and what
you do is to have an automated system
where there's millions of users are
simulated and this uh tool we'll be
using here to simulate this millions of
users is Locust which is an open source
load testing tool that said we're gonna
create this Locus dot py file so here we
have low costs not py there we go and
then in this file we're gonna write out
all the code we'll need to be able to
control or simulate all the users who
will be using the platform so here we
have from low costs we're going to
import sequential
task set
now one thing you should notice the fact
that with Locust we using or we're
defining different tasks and here we're
gonna Define a task whose role will be
to Simply open up a specific image and
then pass this image of via post request
to our API and
we obtain the required outputs so let's
define this
um emotions
so emotions task or let's say detector
task
detector task and this is sequential
text set so we have this and then we
have this task decorator
we have our text decorator right here
we're going to Define our detection
method and here the detection method is
simply going to be this method where we
Define what's actually going to go on
when we
um want to test out our application or
load test our application so here we
have with open we open up a file which
we're going to create locally so we have
this image dot jpg
and there we go so we open this file
as image
and then now we are going to carry out
our post request so we have that push
request and then you see we're going to
specify the path this URL and let's
detect actually want to do for detect
meaning that you could replace this with
tests or some other path you want so for
now it's detect and then
um let's get back here for now let's
detect and then now we specify that we
we're passing a file so here we have
this files and we have the name it's
actually M and then here we have image
so remember we've opened this up as
image so this is image replacing here
now from the API we've designed already
it's name yeah what we have is M so
that's why we specifying this is in and
then once we have this set so this is
our detector task as I said uh the way
we build this with lockups is we Define
different tasks and then once to define
the different tests now we could simply
Define our load tester class so here we
have class
load tester and then we have HTTP user
so this inherits from class HTTP user
and then now we specify the host our
host in this case is going to Simply Be
what we've been using already so it's
this which we deployed on iroku let's
copy this get back here and then paste
this out so we should we should take off
now this detect so we'll take that off
and that's it so we're just passing in
this as our host and then once we pass
this as a host we now specify the task
so this is a task uh in this case our
task is the detector desk okay so that's
it we've we've specified the task
remember you could obviously create many
more different tasks where for now you
just want to work only with this
detector task so that's it we have that
set we could save this and then now we
could go ahead and launch our low costs
so we have low cost uh we specify that
we have a file and it's lock costs dot
UI uh there we go so let's run this um
Locus command not found oh we forgot to
install lockup so let's do peep install
Locust
there we go that should work fine so
install logos
and once we install logos we are gonna
we run this Command right here
and now that we have that installed what
we're gonna do is run back this
so there we go we run this and we could
click on this so let's click there see
what we get see here uh we have all
lockers running so uh yeah we told start
new load test so now the number of users
uh initially is one the spawn rate is
one we're gonna take this on later on
and then notice how we have this our URL
which we have specified so that's our
host which is specified already now
let's start the swarming by our low
costs
um there we go remember this is hosted
online so it's gonna check that up
um
looks like nothing's working well let's
check out this chart statistics well
let's get back here let's get back here
we're getting something like
this
so we got some errors you could see here
I know types of the final load tester
let's save this and then we run this and
see what we get
we run that again but we're still
getting this error so we had to stop and
let's check out why we get in this error
um here we have no tags to find load
tester but you have set a task attribute
on your class maybe you meant to set
tasks yeah
um yeah yeah this should be tasks
because this actually at least remember
as we said we Define different tasks and
then we have our load tester right here
so we could have this task
here we have some other task oops we're
gonna have some other task and so on and
so forth so let's say we have two tasks
let's say we have
tax and then we'll call this tax two
then we are going to come right here and
then put this in this list but given
that we just have a single task let's
take this tax to out and then now as as
we saw here we should have here tasks
and not just tasks so let's save that
and then run this again and now
everything should work fine
okay so we have that we click open
um starts forming
looks like isn't working let's get back
here let's dump this
now let's check out the arrow we're
getting okay no such file as this okay
so remember we don't have this file in
this directory so let's just go ahead
and copy that file
now we've copied the file you can see
that here we have our file here let's go
ahead and rerun this and now everything
should work fine so let's
um click on this open up start the
swarming
and well let's get back we'll see
getting an error
um stop this and check this out
yeah we told that no such file or this
well let's let's rename this rename
um this should be test
image okay so let's run this again
it's fine
open up
start the swarming
and looks like another error
um I'll use this respond
well let's check back here
and you can see that we have this
working as expected so you could see we
have a certain number of requests which
was sent already zero fills we have the
median
um latency we have the 90 percentile
latency 99 percentile the average the
mean and the max so you could see that
it's taking about two seconds for every
user to receive uh whatever
um output the sent in so that's it so we
have this mean and we have this Max now
we could get into the charts and you see
that this is increasing slowly and we
have zero failures so that's very
important we have zero failures with
just a single user and that single user
is um as we saw here getting an average
of now is 1.7 uh milliseconds to receive
the output from the API so that's it
no another thing we could do is actually
stop this and then carry out a new test
where I would have say 10 users so we
want to test when we have 10 users at a
time now this spawn rate year
fixed at the value of 2 will simply mean
that after every second we are going to
add up two users so we're going to start
with two users and then after one second
we go to four after two seconds we go to
Six and so on and so forth until we
attain the maximum row of users which
we've said already here so let's start
the swarming you could see here we start
initially with two we're going to six
and then ten and
um after some time you're gonna have the
first requests so there we go we already
have two two requests another we have
dealing with 10 users here and the
average time it takes for each user to
receive the responses 10 seconds meaning
that our system will take about 10
seconds to reply to well whatever user
whenever we have 10 simultaneous users
so
um let's get into Postman remember here
we have this time elapsed note that this
time elapsed was for the model but what
we're getting now is what each and every
user located in some place in the world
would have as actual
um
time or latency
if we have 10 users now you start seeing
that we start getting failures so let's
check this out
when you run this
um let's run error code logs so here we
let's clear this so you could see that
clearly
so we run error code logs and then we
specify the app emotional detection
neural learn and specify till so we
could get the last
um locks so let's run that
and uh this should run
you could see that we have successful
calls and we also have this calls which
field to see the stitches and your
connection close without response so
let's get back here remember when we had
a single user we didn't have all those
failures so let's stop this
um run your tests and reduce this maybe
to just three users and then see what we
get
well as you can see with um just three
users we have fewer failures that's
about seven percent as you could see
here and it takes on average of 4.5
seconds to receive
um outputs when you send input images
and so with this we've just built and
load Tesla API they showed us clearly
that if you want this to go faster or to
reduce our latency and reduce the
failure percentage which as of now is at
two percent then we would need to
increase our compute capacities so
that's it for the section see you in the
next section
welcome to the section in object
detection object detection is one of the
most popular computer vision tasks and
also a very important one
object detection entails correctly
classifying objects which are in an
image
and also saying exactly where these
objects are located in the image so if
we have this image we see Claudia that
we have an airplane an airplane a person
a person and then we could say a car so
this tools some sort of car now
an object detector not only classifies
these images but also localizes exactly
their positions in the image so this
airplane for example has this bounding
box now a bounding box basically
surrounds or also square a rectangular
box which surrounds the object and then
for this person we have this bounding
box for this this bounding box and this
other airplane we have this bounding box
which is in this
other bottom box
so unlike a classification problem where
when given this kind of input we have as
an output or a one hot Vector for
example which represents the number of
classes we're dealing with so supposing
we have five classes then when given an
input we have to correctly say whether
that input belongs to one of the five
classes
now with object detection we not only
have this but we also have the positions
in the image so like this we have this
position like this and we have several
conventions for these positions one of
the most popular conventions is the
center convention where we have the X
Center y center width and then height
now what does this mean this means that
based on this referential right here so
we could Define a differential right
here where we have this origin now
recall we're used to having we're used
to working with this kind of referential
now the referential for image data is
considered to be this so our origin
stands from here we're moving in the X
Direction and then you're in the y
direction so this is our reference and
then it's based from on this point of
this origin that we actually Define
positions so if we have this airplane
let's consider this bigger airplane so
we could have this bigger airplane we
could Define its bounding Box by its
Center and then it's width so once we
have it Center
obviously and if we're giving us width
we can obviously see that it is in this
rounding box so this is the first
convention the center that's the X
Center under the Y Center the X Center
is basically the distance from this to
the center so suppose the center is
right here so if our Center is here then
the distance from here to this is X
Center and the distance from up to this
is y center so basically that's what we
have
so if you want to link this up like this
we could see clearly how we obtain X
centered distance from year to year and
then why Center distance from this
origin to this which now gives us the
center so that's how we get a center now
we are given the width and then the
height if we're given the width on the
height obviously to get this points or
to get because we have actually Four
Points right here to get all these four
points which make up the bounding box
say this point for this point to obtain
the X and the Y coordinates right here
we simply take this x coordinate and
subtract from the width divided by two
because from this two this is we divided
by two on the diagram it doesn't uh show
clearly that this points at the center
but normally this should be at the
center so we could rearrange this
bounding box now so as we said to get
this we have this accenter minus the
width divided by two to obtain this and
then to get the Y we have the Y Center
plus because this is actually the
positive direction and then this is the
negative direction for the X so for y
this is positive this is negative for y
this is positive for x and then this is
negative for X now to obtain the Y as we
said we have this y center plus the
width of this or rather plus the height
of this divided by two that's how we
obtain this
now to obtain this since we're going
from this we're going the X Center minus
the width divided by 2 we obtain the x
coordinate here to obtain the y
coordinate we have the Y Center minus
because this is a negative Direction so
we have the Y Center minus the height
divided by 2 and this is very similar to
obtain the X here that's a x coordinate
right here we have the X Center here
plus the width divided by two to obtain
the same x coordinate right here is the
X Center plus the width divided by two
obviously these two have the same X card
in it but different Y coordinates to
obtain the y coordinate we have this y
center minus the height divided by two
dropped in the y coordinate here we have
the Y Center plus the height divided by
two either ways once we have these two
continents as this point here and then
this we could always obtain this and
this automatically now another
convention is the X Min y mean x max y
Max combination where we're just given
this causes if we're given this
coordinates and then this coordinates we
could obviously
obtain all this because when Once given
this and then given this
we could
just get the whole box of the magically
so here are the two main conventions we
use to actually locate an object in the
image
this yellow paper published several
years ago was one of the first to come
up with a single neural network which
predicts mounting box and classic
probabilities directly from full images
in one evaluation
now
back then
models are to be precise object
detection models follow this kind of
pipeline while we would have a region
proposal generator a feature extractor
and then a classification unit so you
could look at this uh with a simple rcnn
model where we had uh the input image
the extract regions that's of regions
where the model things we could have
images where the model proposes the
locations of objects and then from your
uh each proposed location is passed into
this feature extractor which obviously
extracts uh futures from this
um warped regions as you could see here
for example this region and then we have
the classifier which tells us whether
this is a person an airplane or say a TV
monitor now with the yellow as we were
saying we have a single Network so let's
uh get here you see we do not have all
that
um different stages now pipelines here
we just have our input image a single
neural network and then we have the
outputs see that there's also this
additional nomax operation here but
we'll look at this shortly now
um the performance of the yellow is
quite impressive or was quite impressive
in terms of speed is especially as now
we can obtain a speeds of up to 45
frames per second and with a yellow
um the smaller version of the yellow we
obtain up to 155 frames per second while
achieving double the mean average
Precision of other real-time detectors
who look at the mean average Precision
subsequently this is the metric used
um generally in object detection
and so a high mean average Precision
means the object detection model is
performing better
another advantage of the YOLO to take
note of is the fact that it reasons
globally about an image
so unlike the sliding windows and the
region proposal based techniques was
looked at the original the region
proposed proposal based techniques like
the RCN and year for the sliding Windows
the way it works is we have
um let's get this way
we have this image right here and then
this window you see you could you can
look at this as a window so this window
is slided through the whole image all I
hear we will just simply pass in the
image as an input with a sliding window
you would have to take each window and
pass into our neural network and you do
that while you're sliding through the
full image so as we're saying getting
back to what we're saying here uh as
compared to the sliding window and the
rcnn kind of models the yellow performs
better in the sense that it sees the
entire image during training and test
time so it implicitly encodes contextual
information about classes as well as
their appearance so you'll find that
models like the rcnn Mystique background
patches in an image for objects because
it can't see the larger context
okay another point is the YOLO learns
generalizable representation of objects
so you'll see that here the yellow which
was which wasn't trained on this kind of
paintings performs quite well you see
the yellow was perf was trained on uh or
this particular version of yellow was
trained on the Pascal VOC data set but
when we test this on this image
paintings you see that it does well so
the yellow models compared to others
learns more generalizable
representations of objects let's now go
in depth and see how the yellow
algorithm works
first things first remember that if you
have though this kind of model says our
YOLO model which you could have your uh
there we go you see this yellow model
has several conflictors and then
completes with this uh connected layer
so we have the feature extractor and the
classifier unit right here anyways we're
not going to get into this now let's
just consider that we have this model
and then we have inputs like this one
see this is our input and then we have
some output right here
now this output obviously is meant to be
a bound and box so here we'll we could
draw this uh mounting box for this woman
here so this shows that uh or this
bounding box is for this uh
this person
and then let's take this off
um add the stroke oh let's change that
color so here we have this here this
this person detected and then we also
have this other person right here so
we'll have something like this see that
so we have now these two detections one
for this woman and uh and this other one
for this other uh person and so we're
gonna build a model which is this one
which takes in this kind of input output
Pairs and then learns to get those
inputs and predict the the outputs
correctly such that when given a new
input it could uh tell us where every
object is located and what type of
object it is precisely
now that said the actual outputs
wouldn't be this image with this bottom
box the actual output will be different
from what we are seeing here now the way
this outputs are created is uh using
some sort of encoding system where we
have this input which is breaking up
into uh some greed cells so right here
let's take the pen so right here you see
we have uh let's suppose that we have
this 224 by 224
um input image that's this image here to
24 by 224 this one here and then we
break this up into several degrees cells
so this is a single grid cell another
one and so on and so forth now each grid
cellular given that we have
um seven grid cells so we have a seven
by seven output see that we have one two
three four five six seven one two three
four five six seven so that's it and now
each of this is going to be 32
by 32 so it's like 32 by 32 patches so
we take uh each patch here combine them
to from 224 by 224 or better steel we
take the 224 image and break it up into
32 by 32 grid cells see that
now once we have this ready or once we
once we have uh some somehow broken up
our image into this uh grid cells we are
then going to encode the outputs based
on the locations of the center of our
bonding boxes right here so you see we
have that we're going to redraw this
Bound in boxes so that you see that uh
clearly let's increase this to say five
okay so here we are having this rounding
box right here see this bounding box
and then it has a center at about this
position here see that position uh if
you if you want to locate this year it
falls about this around this year so you
see it's about this now uh for this
other person we have another bounding
box like this
see that it's all about in box and the
center is about this about around the
child's nose so it's around here you see
that so what we're gonna do now is we're
gonna
um have each and every one of this let's
change this color we're gonna have each
and every one of this uh sorry we're
gonna have every one of this here
having certain values
now in the case where the cell like this
one let's let's uh make this a bit more
transparent the case will sell
like this one let's do 20 so you could
see that better so here we're gonna have
uh as we're saying in the case where a
cell like this one which doesn't contain
an object then we'll say okay it's first
value will be a zero see that this first
value will be zero
skip back and here our first value is
zero so for this cell to sell your
office value is zero now for this artist
cell
um here where the the the there is an
object there
you see
this value will be a one
you see that so each and every cellular
each and every cellular has or takes
certain values based on whether there is
an object or not
now as you can see the cell you have a
zero the zero in fact all the zero and
accept this two which we put in red
which will take values of one and this
is simply because it happens that the
centers of the bottom boxes fall in
those cells so that's the first step now
once we have this first step the next
thing we want to do is we want to locate
the exact position of our images so the
first thing is we want to know whether
there's first of all an image that's by
encoding it like this the next thing you
want to know is the exact position now
this exact position
uh obviously depends on the kind of uh
the way we want to represent our
bounding boxes now we could represent
our bounding Boxes by specifying x mean
x mean y mean
and x max
y Max
with this kind of representation an
object like this oh maybe right here or
let's say person you write your
will have this uh values or will make
use of these values to locate this
person so we make use of this point here
which is x mean y mean and this other
point here which is x max y Max with
respect to the origin which is at the
top left corner so this is our origin
right here you see that so we go X steps
and Y steps downward then here x steps
to the right y steps downward to locate
this uh person now once we once we've
done this we could we we could just put
this out here so we could say okay we're
creating our outputs remember our M here
is to create our output so we're
creating our outputs we know for every
cell or for every grid cell where
objects are located that's it
then now to get the bottom boxes we
could make use of this but what's
important to note here is the notation
used by the authors of the YOLO V1 paper
was instead X Center
y center
then the width and the height see that
of the bounding box obviously none of
the image so here instead of having
making use of X Min or y mean x max y
Max we make use of X Center which is the
center
y center so we'll go x y
and then we look for the width of this
box the width and also the height of the
box
so let's get back so that's that that's
basically how we do that and then
there's another special encoding which
is done
and what they actually do is
for the width and the height of the
bottom box they're gonna divide this by
Big W where Big W is the of is a width
of the whole image so if our image is
224 by 224 we'll take this width let's
suppose that the Swedish say 160 so
we'll take 160 divided by 224 and get
our width and then for the height we'll
do the same thing so here if we have the
height of say 200 we'll take 200 by 224
and we get that so it's h divided by the
height of the whole image see that now
once we have that we we here for this
xcyc we're gonna do something similar
but not divided by the whole width or
and also not divided by the height of
the image what we are going to do here
is we are going to have this XC
with respect to its specific grid cell
now let's explain let's pull this way so
you could see that clearer so we're
supposing that we have this here and
we've already seen how to get for the
width and the height take that divided
by the total width and the for the
height divided by the total height total
width and total height in our example is
224. now for the XC and YC uh here for
example we have this our XC YC this for
this other objects our xcyc let's
consider the example of let's consider
this example here so what we're saying
is we are not going to take this with
respect to the full image instead we're
going to see uh we're gonna take this
grid cell and suppose that this distance
is one and we take this and suppose that
this distance towards one now our origin
here is this see this points our origin
now if we for this cell this would be
our origin and this will be our distance
one and here our distance one
now if this uh distance one so this has
one then this point here let's say this
point here
will be a fraction of one basically so
it'll be a value between zero and one
now if we take this distance we could
approximate this to be about zero point
say five six and then this this test is
about say 0.7 so in this case XC will be
this distance and Y C will be this
distance in that case we'll have
0.56 and 0.7
so that's it now once we have that the
next thing we'll do is we'll just simply
put that out here so we would have that
XC uh with respect to the grid cell
we'll write that G and then we'll have
uh y c
G that's it so here we now know how to
obtain these values let's change the
color back so here we would have say 0.7
0.0.056 0.7 so that's how we have this
now once we once we get this remember we
already have one year so the next one we
have is x c g
for the next part if we have a a data
set where we have say 20 classes like
the Pascal vocal Set uh with the cocoa
data set where we have 80 classes uh
what we would have from here see we've
had whether object is there or not if
the object is there we want to get this
location now from the location we want
to know what object exactly is found
there so yeah we suppose that we have 20
classes see now uh initially everyone
here is zero so we have 20 we're just
gonna align 20 zeros so basically we
have this oh there's 20 zeros here now
uh if the person even you know in our
classes we decide that the person
occupies the say the third position in a
list of classes so we could we could
have a class or let's just let's just
check out the list of of Pascal VOC
classes whereas you can see here we have
this 20 different classes and then if we
count this we have one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen notice
how this person is at the 15th position
15 16 17 18 19 20. okay so we have the
person
um at that 15th position
and so this means that when encoding our
image here a winning code in our output
would have to take that into
consideration we will simply do
uh one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen fifteen so you're at this
position will change this and put a one
instead of the zero which all the other
classes get so we take this off and then
we have a one right here you see that so
we have 15 16 17 18 19 20. now if you
have another data set with fewer classes
say eight classes this will be uh of
length eight
now we've seen how for each and every
one of these grid cells which actually
sells 49 of them because we have seven
by seven we have uh this encodings
that's so what our model sees or what
our model gets as output isn't this but
instead this kind of output so now we're
gonna prepare our data set such that we
have an input image which is this and
then an output level which is going to
be this level right here and then the
model is going to struggle to be able to
correctly produce these kinds of outputs
and so as we've just uh discussed our
output will be of shape this output here
will be of shape 7 by 7. by
20 see number of classes 20 plus five
okay five plus twenty
which is in fact seven
by seven
by 25 so this is what our level will
look like
so while we get our input and our
outputs I want to get an input and the
bounding boxes with the specific classes
we're going to create this kinds of
outputs from the labels we get depending
on our data set
nonetheless when we zoom into this model
right here we notice that we're taking
some input and then at a level of the
output we have seven by seven by Thirty
instead of 7 by 7 by 25. now the reason
why we have this is simple
we have the first position let's reduce
this we have the first position
which tells us whether there is an
object or not so that's one and then the
next position gives us the location with
the xcyc w and H so here we have the
position yo the air we have the position
so we have x y w h
now the next ones give us the classes or
or tells us what class our object
belongs to so
um here we would have a series of zeros
at some point we will have a one and
then we have your zeros but the length
of this year is 20 now 20 plus 5 is oh
25 obviously Which is less than 30. now
to understand why this is actually 30
oops to understand why this is actually
what we'll do is let's take this off
what we'll do is we'll suppose that we
have
for every cell
two boxes responsible
for locating the object
so
instead of having this your only this uh
particular box so we suppose that this
is a box let's take the pen with the
person that this year
this year is a box
this one is a box instead of having only
this box we're gonna make two boxes
responsible for uh locating the object
remember this is this parameters also
locate the object because first of all
it tells us whether the object is found
in the cell or not and here it tells us
it gives us the exact coordinates of the
objects this one is for the classes
separate so the next thing we'll do is
we'll take this and multiply by two so
let's shift this again
we have this and then we paste that out
see now if if we have the number of
boxes to be three they'll just be
multiplied twice but in the in the
yellow V1 paper they use they use B to
be they consider B to be equal to you
could check that out here b equal to
so uh that's it we see we now have two
boxes responsible for locating the
object in that image so when uh
designing the levels that we we could
design with just one because we know
that this does the correct answer but
what the model will predict will be two
values you see it will predict this two
we'll play this and predict this now the
reason why we're doing this is because
we want that uh one of these boxes or
any one of these boxes should be more
specialized depending on the size of the
object now as we've seen here
we're dealing with a relatively large
objects with respect to the to the image
actually but what if we have an image of
a person where the person is uh say at
just a very say we have a very uh very
small person to image ratio like this
where we will have a bounding box which
will be small
compared to the whole image in that case
what we want is for the model
or for these boxes to be specialized
such that maybe this first box will will
learn to detect the smaller objects
while this one learns to detect the
larger objects so that's it that's how
we construct this output so we
understand how to construct the levels
and then how to construct the model
outputs remember we have to update this
weight such that the difference between
the levels
and the model output let's say o
is minimized
getting back to the paper we see the
exact structure of the YOLO model so
right here we start with some kind of
layer count layer Max pool layer
um conf layer Max pool we have several
comp layers then a Max pool then we have
this other conflictors this year times
four the max pool completers then count
flares then finally we have the fully
connected layers for classification so
this is for feature extraction this year
feature extraction and then this is for
classification
now for the training what they do is
they pre-train this model on imagenet
with 1000 classes but note that this
pre-training is for the problem of
classification so this usual
classification problem and then the
pre-train this model
for over a week here and achieve a top
five personal accuracy of 88 percent and
then from this model they add four
convolutional layers and two fully
connected layers we randomly initialized
weights so while going going doing the
training for the object detection we
have weights from the previous training
that's from the pre-trained weights from
the image net and then add some uh the
other four though actually spoke of four
so this should be this
um and this one
this one this last two here
so they add up four count layers and to
connect a fully connected layers uh
which have been randomly initialized as
I said here
now uh following the example okay that's
it detection often requires finding
grain visual information so we increase
the input resolution of the network from
2 to 224 by 224 to 448 by 448 so what
they did was they trained on 224 by 224
images and then at detection time we
used 448 by 448 images now they also use
a linear activation function for the
final layer and other layers use the
following leaky relu so they use the
relu for the final and then the Leaky
relu for the all other layers as the
activation function now as a recall for
that
we have our relu which is simply this
what the relu does is all values
all values it takes which are less less
than zero
are sent to zero and all values greater
than zero are maintained so if you if
you pass in a value like three well the
other to the relu you get back three but
if you pass say negative 0.5
negative 0.5 what you get will be zero
because all negative values are sent to
zero and all positive values are
maintained basically is uh you remain x
if x is greater than R equals zero and
you go to zero if x is less than zero
now uh for the final or rather for all
the other this is for the final layer
this is what they use for the final
layer now for all the other layers they
use the Leaky relu for the Leaky relu
what we have is not uh this year not
this straight horizontal line but
instead something like this see
something a bit slanted
and then here is still maintaining the
positive still maintained so we still
have
still X
it Still Remains X for X greater than or
equals zero but for this one it goes to
0.1 x
for x
Less Than Zero so for all negative
values we will have a 0.1 x so it means
our gradient here this gradient is going
to be 0.1 so the bottom border too much
if you don't understand the notion of
gradient anyway we have that
we have this uh it means that if we if
we send a value like say negative 0.5
now what we will get will be negative
0.5 times 0.1 a normal zero so that's
the difference and this is activation
function use uh everywhere in the model
except for the last
um layer so that's what the that's
what's defined right here now the the
the loss function that we here the uses
the sum square error so that's the
simple loss function they use and that's
why at the beginning the speak of
um
we frame object detection as a
regression problem so that's it so it's
it's like a simple regression problem
actually
that is the sum square of the difference
between the model output and the
expected output which is the levels
now that we understand globally how the
models build and the training process
let's get to look in depth into this
loss function
so right here we have this loss function
and then we're supposing that we have
this levels here so here are levels and
then here's what the model predicts
remember we have seven by seven seven by
seven
um cells with cells by 30 for the
model's predictions whereas the levels
are seven by seven by 25. see that so we
have this first five for the location
this location this location we have to
add this uh one year
oops let's change the color back to Red
so you see that clearer so we we have
this location here
foreign
there we go
we have this location here
that's it we have this five this five
and we have the classes
here we also have the classes
and then we have this five right here
now the way we obtain the loss is we
break it up into several parts we'll
we'll look at this part first we'll
start with this part now this part you
see you just basically adding the path
of the first part the next part the spot
this part and this part for this first
part here this it punishes the model
when it makes errors with respect to
whether there is an object in a
particular grid cell or not so if we
have for this grid cell one as a level
we're expecting the model to predict one
year or and a one right here so this
means that what will happen here is
we're gonna go through we see the sum
from I equals zero to S Square s Square
here in our case s is seven so s square
is seven square which is 49 so we go
through each and every grid cellular
which is logical we go through each and
every one of this so we go to each and
every one of those 49 different grid
cells and then we'll calculate the
difference see this the we have c i c i
Chapel that's c i minus C I shall Square
so we have this year minus this square
and then we add all those up
now also notice that there's a double
sum in your the reason why we have this
double sum is because we're actually
going to take this minus this plus this
minus this see that take this minus this
plus this minus this if we had say five
or three boxes then we'll have three of
this we'll have one two and we'll add
another one before the the classes so in
that case it will go three times so uh
hopefully that's clear but one thing you
notice is this uh this uh notation here
one
one of obj I or obj is actually object
one of object I so you notice this
notation right here now or this notation
let's get back and just circle that out
here so it's clear so this is this is it
right here you'll notice this and what
you say in the paper is this uh one obji
notation denotes if an object appears in
cell I and this one obj IJ because this
is actually I J not I IJ did not that
the JS bound and box that's here we have
two bounding boxes so either this
bounding box or this bounding box uh
predictor in cell I so I is the cell
clearly see that I
goes to not 49 and then J goes to 2.
um if if we if we have this then it
should be I equal 1 to 49 then this
should be J equal one two two
this means that there's a slight errand
notation right here anyways we
understand that we're going from 1 to 49
and then we're going from one to two
because we're basically going through
each cell here and we're also going
through each and every one of those
boxes now getting back to our one IJ or
one obgig notation we're saying that uh
we've already seen that this denotes
that the Jade bound and box predictor in
cell I in a given cell is responsible
for that prediction you see that now
what does this mean it means that if a
particular like your if a particular box
if this box is not responsible for the
prediction then we are not going to
include the when Computing this error
now how do we know whether this box or
this box is responsible for the
prediction the way we get this is simple
uh let's pull this to the right oh let's
reduce that so we could get more space
so what happens is
um let's suppose we have
um this image
and then we have one object here and we
have another object here then we have
some bounding boxes
so we have this bottom box and we have
this other bottom box
now
um for this for this year we we have a
particular cell let's suppose our we're
breaking this up and then we have a
given grid cell like this one which is
responsible for predicting this object
now this the first box you see this
first box will predict maybe this
Browning box and then the next box will
predict maybe this bottom box
now what we say we predict this one this
will predict this bounding box and the
other will predict this is actually
because they have different values for
XC y c w h see this quadruplet here is
different from this other quadruplet and
because they are different it means that
uh obviously the bottom box that you get
will be different and because those
those two bounding boxes you get will be
different it means that you you can now
compare which of this two is closest
to the actual mounting box which is this
so this is the actual and this is what
the model predicts so we're comparing
those two they're competing for which of
them is closest to the actual so let's
suppose that the actual is is something
like this uh suppose that actually
something like this
uh here so we have something like this
okay so in that case it's clear that
this one let's look for a neutral color
now
it's clear that this because we remember
we are having this one this box
competing with this black box
competing with this black box so this is
B1 and B2 to compared in
but the the blue box is the actual one B
we'll just call that b so we're going to
compare the difference
between uh B1 and B
and the difference between B2 and B
now the one which is uh which resembles
B the most as the one which has the
least the the smaller difference will be
the one responsible as I said here
for that prediction you see that so uh
in our case here it's clear that B1 is
responsible so for this particular case
because for a different grid cell we may
have B2 responsible for whatever grid
cell you may have again B2 or B1 it just
depends on on what on this uh difference
between the the the bottom box by that
box specific box and the actual bounding
box now that said another question you
may ask yourself is how do we compare
this bounding boxes Now The Way We
compare these bounding boxes is by using
the ious core so if we have two bounding
boxes like this
uh we have these two bottom boxes
and then we have let's see
this one
let's say we have this other box here
and then we also have this one something
like this
if we were to compare the how close this
one this pair this pair of boxes
is compared to how close is other Paris
you'll see clearly that this pair is
closer
or simply put they are more closer to
each other as compared to this other
pair right here
now the the way we look at this is we
compute the area between the two boxes
so that's it you look for this area of
the intersection so this is their
intersection
and then so we have your we'll call this
IOU IOU actually let's just put it right
here IOU actually stands for
intersection over Union intersection
divided which is equal the intersection
we'll call it intersection
divided by the Union
so if you take for example this
intersection here and divide by the area
this area plus this area
then that's actually including the the
those intersections basically this is
this is the intersection and then let's
change this so you can see clearla and
this is the Union
see this this is our Union
that's it so that's our Union and this
is our intersection so we take this area
divided by all this area here and we get
the eye of your score we're going to
repeat the same process for this one
where this is our Union
now you could see clearly that this one
would have a higher IOU compared to this
one and so this is how we compute or we
know which of the boxes is responsible
for that prediction
now getting back here
let's get back to our loss function as
we're saying we're gonna have uh that if
this box for example if it happens that
this box B1 here this box here is
responsible for the prediction then
would have this difference times one see
times one now if this box is not
responsible then we have times zero so
this this is not going to be considered
when we Computing this loss see that
that's it so it's true we we summon
through the two boxes but actually we're
going to take only or consider only one
when calculating this difference for
this one We're not gonna we're gonna
omit it now we move on to the next this
other one year
computes or permits us to
have grid cells or
permits us to correctly predict when
there is no object notice here this is
No Object here is object so what we are
having here is for the cells where we
have an object like you see well where
the level you have the cell and the cell
we're gonna use this here where there is
no object we're gonna use instead this
one year
and you're basically when there is no
object we're just going to take the the
output or the value we have here minus
the value we have here
then plus the value we have here minus
now the next I also know that we have
this Lambda No Object now in the paper
the talk a little bit more about this
here we have to to remedy this uh first
of all let's understand this
yeah they say they use the sum square
error because it is easy to optimize
however it does not perfectly align with
our goal of maximizing the average
position
it weighs localization error equally
with classification error which may not
be ideal
also in every image many Greek cells do
not contain any object so this pushes
the confidence course of those cells
towards zero
often overpowering ingredients from
cells that do not contain objects
now this can lead to model and stability
cause and training to diverge early on
so to remedy this they increase the loss
from the bottom box coordinate
predictions and decrease the loss from
the confidence predictions for boxes
that don't contain objects we use a
parameter we use the two parameters
Lambda coordinates this photo the the
positioning and Lambda no objects for
when we have no objects to accomplish
this so we set uh Lambda coordinates for
five and Lambda objects to 0.5
so as we were saying this Lambda No
Object here 0.5 and Lambda coordinate is
five as they've given us right here now
what can reduce from this from this
looking at these formulas here is that
the model will be punished more severely
if
um it has or if a particular grid cell
was meant to predict an object and it
didn't predict that
as compared to when
it doesn't have an object and it didn't
predict correctly so for the object we
have a more punishment as compared to
this one because this Lambda no object
is 0.5
now for the coordinates it receives
highest punishment year because the as
we as we have Lambda coordinate equal
five for the classes we still record one
so here we have one
0.51 and five five
now getting back here we have this one
for the classes uh basically what we
have here is we have this condition so
this is one object or OBG of I uh this
this is the one was ob one obj IJ so
notice that this is now I now here
basically what we're having is we
calculating this difference only when
that grid cell has an object so if uh
like in the level here if we have a one
like for these two grid cells then we'll
go ahead and compute this difference
but in the case where we have uh No
Object like in the cell in the cell the
cell and the cell or all of the cells
inside this two then we wouldn't uh get
into this so we'll just keep that note
also we have this
um oh sorry we have we actually here we
wouldn't get into this so here we have
just one
now uh this this what we do here is
similar to what we're gonna do for the
coordinates with the coordinates we have
um
the same process process where if there
is no object we wouldn't go ahead to
compute this difference so like here if
this is zero then we'll skip this now if
it is one then we'll go ahead and
compute the difference between this and
this and that's what we have here now
this is the x minus X of bar square plus
the X Y minus y box because basically
this x minus this square plus this minus
this square and then here and also
notice that your this this 2 is squared
and then it's added up uh and then here
we have the the square root of the width
minus the square root of the auto width
or the predicted width all of that
square plus the square root of the
height minus the square root of the
predicted height all of that squared and
then
um they add this up and multiply by
Lambda coordinates
but you should be noted that we are only
going to compute this if we happen to
fall in a box which is responsible for
that prediction so if this box is
responsible for the prediction it means
that we are not going to make or we're
not going to compute this for this uh
box right here we're not going to
compare this and this we're going to do
this and this because this box is
responsible and we've seen already what
it means by a box being responsible for
the prediction
uh getting back to the paper let's get
back up here now what we have also is
that the sum Square Arrow or equally
ways errors in large boxes and small
boxes so the error metric should reflect
that small deviations in large boxes
matter less than in small boxes to
partially address this we predict the
square root of the bounding box width
and height instead of the width and
height directly so what you're saying is
if we have this couple here
these two boxes and then we have this
deviation
or we have this difference which we're
trying to compute for the loss and then
we have also this smaller boxes here
with this similar difference so let's
let's try to have something similar to
that we have something like this
um hope it's similar enough so we have
something like this
uh with the initial method we will have
W minus W bar or shape or t of the
square
Plus
the height minus the height bar
Square
where this is W here's what the level
expects and although W by is what the
model predicts so the same the same for
the h and the H bar now what they want
is that if we have this difference here
or or better so let's say that uh what
is going on with this year is that
if we have this year these two boxes
this difference because the this is
equal difference you see this difference
is the same if we have this here then uh
let's say the difference is five let's
let's suppose that this difference is
five your difference is five
that's the width and the height
difference is five then we'll have a
five square plus five squared as 50.
now for this small box here this is five
and then year is five
then we also have 50.
but this is not what we want the reason
why we don't want this is because uh
this kind of difference for smaller
boxes
is
more important than this difference for
this bigger boxes so it's just like you
you supposing that you have say
um
uh say you have a loaf of bread like
this suppose we have a loaf of bread and
then you you have this part your
which color control
now uh compared to a case where you have
the smaller loaf of bread you'll find
that cutting off this part here it's
like curd enough probably a third of my
loaf whereas or for this case this was
like cutting out say one tenth of my
loaf so so clearly from here the loss is
less felt as compared to this other one
and so to as I say in the paper it's a
remedy the situation at the square root
year now let's add the square root and
see this difference now uh the square
root of uh let's see let's say this was
30 and this was 25 so we had five and
then it was 30 and 25. the square root
of 30 now is uh let's say this is 30.
with 30 and uh for for this other one so
this one has with high 30 and the other
one has width height 25.
so this gave us the difference which was
five and that's how we had this
difference here now what we when we take
now the square root of 30 let's take the
square root of 30.
um the square root
of 30
that's 5.47 okay so 5.47 now minus the
square root of 25 will be
0.47 see
0.47 which one you square
um let's compute that directly which
when you are going to square it
um
will give you approximately zero point
two two
see so you have 0.22 Plus 0.22
now that will give us 0.44
or zero point
four four
this two big boxes now for the smaller
boxes let's suppose that this one was um
say because we want to have a difference
of five we could say 10 and 5. so here
we had 10 by 10 and here we have five by
five
um in that case we will have square root
of 10
minus square root of 5.
and now when you compute that you would
have uh zero point
eight four
so what I mean here is when you take the
square root of 10 minus the square root
of 5 and you square it gives you 0.84
0.84 plus 0.84 will give you about 1.6
let's say 1.6 anyway that's already much
greater than 0.44 it means that the
model is penalized more now for making
this error as compared to making this
error
so that now solved the problem of where
the the model would have or penalized
the other model would have been
penalized in the same way for this uh
same difference
even when the size of the size
difference between these two boxes is
quite considerable now that's set from
here this the train for over 135 eBooks
on training validation data sets from
Pascal of VLC and uh 2007 and 2012. uh
we test we tested on 2012 we also
include the VOC 2007 testing for
training uh test data for training then
throughout training we use a buy set of
64 momentum of 0.9 and Decay that's with
decay of
0.0005 learning ratio was as follows for
the first ebooks will slowly raise the
learning rate from 10 to negative 3 so
10 to the negative 2 so started with a
relatively lower learning rate slowly
increase in it because if we start at a
high learning rate the model often
diverges due to unstable gradients so we
continue training with 10 to the
negative 2 that's after going from this
we'll slowly increase to 10 to the
negative 2 and let it continue to
training with this tensor negative 2 for
75 epochs then 10 to the negative 3 for
30 ebooks so after this 75 ebooks the
drop to 10 to negative 3 and then
finally drop against density negative
four four Thirty ebooks that makes now
um 75 plus 30 that's 105.
uh plus 30 135 ebooks okay so to avoid
overfilling we use drop out and
extensive data augmentation drop out
layer will read 0.5 after the first
connected layer prevent Squad up
adaptation between the layers for the
documentation they introduce random
scaling and translations of up to 20 of
the original image size we also randomly
adjust the exposure and saturation of
the image up by up to a factor of 1.5 in
the HSV color space
now given that after the detection has
been made Let's Get Back To The Top uh
that's that's after or let's say after
the model has been trained we would get
detections like this let's increase this
we would get detections like this so we
might have many more detections than
expected so we're gonna apply the
non-max suppression algorithm to remove
those uh cells or rather to remove those
bounding boxes which are repeated around
a certain region and focus only on
bounding boxes which have the highest
probabilities course so like this one
you see the thickness here signifies the
probability is called the probability of
an object being that location see that
so that's why we're left with this after
the non-max operation
now the weight is normal suppression
algorithm works is as such we have
um after the person after the model has
been trained we pass this input image
and we may get predictions like this now
let's let's suppose that the this one
this this two whites have the highest
probabilities and then we we also have
some other predictions
uh we have maybe say this other
partition here
oh that's it we have see another
prediction around here
something like this
now what we're gonna do is we're gonna
consider that for a particular object
let's say this this bottom box right
here for a particular bonding box uh we
look at this probability and compare
with that of the bounding box around it
and obviously it's another bounding box
surrounds or is very close to this
bounding box we look at the IOU so if we
fix the IOU to uh the threshold of 0.5
it means that if we're taking this box
for example questioning this box then
any box with an IOU that's any box which
is close enough to this here uh search
that is IOU is greater than 0.5 meaning
that they are very close
then we are going to remove that
bounding box so it means that we're
going to take this off because they are
already very closed
so you see that now you could you could
play around with this value meaning that
you could take say 0.2 or even 0.7
depending on your your the data set
you're working with now so what we're
saying is because these two are very
close to each other we take that off now
obviously they must be put in the same
object now uh if we have another box
like this one if we had another box like
this one
see suppose we had on that box like this
one then this box will not be taken off
because the IOU is less than 0.5 so when
the i o is greater than 0.5 we know that
they are very close to each other we
compare their probabilities the one with
the highest probability is going to win
the other one is going to be taken off
and the time known Max suppression so if
you are not in you're not a Max we're
going to suppress you so we surprised
all of that and you see this one is left
now for this year we're gonna say okay
this one has the highest probability
we're not going to compare this with
this because obviously the the IOU will
be less than 0.5 now we're going to take
this one and this one we're going to
compare this to the the IOU is going to
be greater than 0.5 and so yeah we're
going to remove this other one so this
one
here will be taken off
you see this one is still left so or
that'll be it will be left now with
these three predictions uh anyway
um generally when training our YOLO
model we aim to even be able to avoid
the non-max suppression as as a whole
and
other you know variants have been
developed to try to reduce their
dependence on the normal Max operation
other variants are like the yellow
9000 yellow V2 yellow V3 you know V4 you
also have yellow V5 you know X you know
R which perform even better than this
yellow V1 we're discussing right here so
uh here you have some tables which
compare to other
um methods see you could always look
review this see here fast rcnn you have
the yellow you see that it performs
better than the than the yellow
um but this one is faster than the fast
rcnn
we also have this comparison table for
different objects see for different
objects we see the the Precision for
this different objects and we compare
with this different methods here we have
the yellow
then you could get down here
see the recall
see that we've already had a tutorial on
the positional recall so you should be
able to understand this uh if you're new
to that you could check out our previous
videos
um yeah this is some quantitative
results in the VOC 2007 because1 people
aren't these sets so that it performs
best on the on the this VOC 2007 it
performs best on the Picasso reference
based on the people art data set
um let's get back here
oh okay this is fast rcnn while you're
comparing with the with the with the
simple rcnn okay so that's it uh we see
that with the Picasso and the people art
it performs it out performs other
methods like rcnn means that it's uh it
has marginalization capacities as
compared to other uh methods and
techniques here we have some limitations
of the yellow usually imposes strong
spatial constraints and modern boxes so
uh since each grid cell only predicts
two boxes and can only have one class so
this means that uh let's get back here
this means that if we have uh if we had
a person who was say stallion just
behind right be any sort of person here
it would have been difficult to predict
this person and this other person and
also in the case where we have images
where the objects are quite small so we
have some very small objects and act up
like this this YOLO more algorithm or
this yellow model we find it difficult
in detecting each and every one of them
um getting back to the paper I'm all the
struggles with small objects that appear
in groups such as Flux Of of birds since
our mother learns to predict burning
boxes from data it struggles to
generalize the objects in the new
unusual aspect ratio or configuration so
uh this has been trained on the Pascal
of EOC data set where the objects have
certain aspect ratios now I may turn it
out you have a different data set where
the aspect ratio is different bias per
ratio we simply meaning the the width to
height ratio so it's this ratio right
here this this aspect ratio can be say
two by five people taking height by
width then you're always going to be
like say three by two so what oh what
goes on here is you've trained this on
Pascal VOC data set where you have a
specific as or a general uh kind of
aspect ratio or aspect ratios but when
this is taken to
um different images where the aspect
ratios aren't similar to that of the
Pascal VOC then the past the yellow
model finds it difficult or struggles to
generalize in such situations
um finally we went while train while we
train on a loss function that
approximates detection performance our
loss function trees errors the same
small bounding boxes versus large
bounding boxes
and this here that the main source of
error is incorrect localizations that
said we're done with this uh review of
the yellow paper the next section we are
going to uh build this Yolo from scratch
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we shall
focus on preparing our Pascal VOC data
set using the tensorflow dataset
pipeline
so yeah on Kegel we have this Pascal VOC
data set which is made available by Wang
hang China and it's made of those five
different directories that is
annotations image sets jpeg images
segmentation class and segmentation
object nonetheless we shall be making
use of the jpeg images and annotations
for our object detection problem then
now get into the code we are going to
start by installing kaggle we are going
to copy this cargo.json file into this
directory which we just created now note
that this cargo that Json file as we've
seen already is gotten from our Kegel
account so you get this from your Google
account and you copy out here and then
now after this copy you
change the access mode of the file and
then start with the data set downloading
now to download this or to have that
command you just simply scroll like this
get your copy API command and you paste
it out here so uh what we have here is
simply what we've copied so that's it
that's how we we download this data set
so we run that and we download the data
set now once this will be downloaded
we'll go ahead to unzip the content of
that data set into a data set directory
right now we will have our data set
there we go we have our data set
um we pick out this one here
and you see we have the annotations
image sets jpegs segmentation class and
segmentation object you could open up
this and this okay so that's it now what
we'll do is we're gonna Define some
variables here we have our trained
images which is simply this path to this
jpeg images we have our train maps which
is simply the path to the annotations so
that's it and then we have our classes
so Pascal VOC data set
um takes in 20 classes from airplane
right up to TV monitor then we have B
set to two now to understand the
significance of this B remember from the
paper that we had seen that the
image is divided into an S by S grid and
for each grid cell uh and each grid cell
predicts B mounting boxes now here the
defined s to B7 and then B to B2 so
that's the this number of bounding boxes
which we are considering to be B
and that's exactly what we have here so
um that said we have number of classes
which is simply from year 20 we have
the image height and width which is
considered to be 224 we have the split
size s which is
um 224 divided by 32 that is equals
seven we've just seen that this is
actually s in the paper we have number
of epochs a hundred
um learning rate
um defined uh although we have some sort
of learning reshadowing so we could take
this off
um and here we could say 135 then we
have a batch size of 32 so that's it we
Define all this and then we move to the
pre-processing of our annotations now
given that those annotations are
essentially this XML files we have here
what we're going to be using is this
Elementary from this XML package which
we'll use to parse this XML data right
here so diving into the code you could
see here we have the file name which is
passed
into this parse method from which we
obtain a tree then from the tree we
could get its root
once we obtain the roots we can now get
the tree size see we have root DOT fine
and we specify size and then once we
have this tree size we could get the
height of a specific image and its width
so here we have width
um width and height that is how we
obtain this tool from the size stack so
we could also obtain the depth from here
let's let's copy this
and
um paste our year and then let's say we
want to get the debt
um yeah we specify depth
and then you see we obtain the text so
let's run that and then get the depth we
run that and then let's
um have
pre-process XML and then the file name
it's train maps actually it's actually
the file path
um train maps plus we have this file 207
um 207
um33.xml okay so it's actually this
exact file here see this if you look up
here or if you look at this here file
name is exact same file name so let's
run this and then see what we get
um there we go we should have okay so we
have 366 for the height here we have 500
for the width
and then we have three for the depth
we've converted all this into floats
okay so now we've done with obtaining
the images
um width and height which are all in
this size tag let's now move on to
obtaining the different bounding boxes
of the different objects so you see here
we had root dot find size that's because
uh we have a single size for that image
now here you see we have rodent find all
objects and that's because we will have
many or we could have many objects for a
single image here again single size but
here uh grading or a possibility of
having more than one object so that's
why you always specify find all so uh we
are going to find all objects meaning
that we are going to get into each and
every object tag we have here you see
this is an object this is another object
uh if we scroll down we'll see we have
another object so essentially in this
image we have one two two three
objects okay so we have these three
different objects
and now for each and every bounding box
in this object like this is our object
tree here if we pick out a specific
object so here we pick out this object
for example we have we go through each
and every bounding box
in this object and we take its mean
that's x mean y mean X Max and Y Max so
that's exactly what we do here you see
we have bounding box that's fine now x
mean and then we convert that to text we
have Wyoming text xmax and Y Max and at
the end of this we now convert this into
a float so that's how we obtain x mean
what I mean X Max and Y Max now you'll
notice that we have a break here and the
reason why we want to have this is
because
um for a particular object we just need
a single bottom box so if we have other
bonding boxes
we are not going to take those into
consideration
okay so that said now what we'll do is
we're going to print out x mean
um y mean x max y Max and yeah x max my
Max okay so let's print this out for
each and every object now let's run this
and see what we get
as we expect you see we have 9 107 499
263 and that's exactly what we have here
we have 421 200 482 226 and then finally
we have this so here are three different
objects now what if we try out another
different image so let's change this to
32 we run that and see what we get yes
it's on xml5 series
um 32 instead of 33. you see now we have
actually four different objects and so
we have this four different bounding
boxes which you could see here we have
object object object and object
now if you consider this image here you
see we put place a cursor on this point
we have you could read from here we have
188 so it matches up with this year see
this 26 189 and then here we have
um 46 to 40 which is our width 44 to 38.
now in order for us to make it easier
when working with the yellow encodings
what we are going to do is we are going
to get the center of this mounting box
so the center should be around this
point here now that Center is about 35
215 so here we have 30 oops uh let's get
a plan so here is about
and then uh now we've got in the center
we could also get the width the width
um is
about 18.
and then the height
the height
is about 238 minus 189
that's 49. so we we now have the center
which is this we have the width and then
we have the height and then what we'll
do is we'll divide all this by the total
width
and total height of the image so for 35
would take 35 divided by the total width
the total width of this is
um 500 so we have 35 divided by 500. and
then we'll have
um
215 divided by
um well this 215 is divided by the
height that is 281 because this this
year is
our x coordinate and then this is our
y-coordinate so this is with respect to
the width and then this respect to the
height so this is divided by
230 uh 281 okay so we take this divided
by 500 and then this divided by 281 then
we have the width which is 18 divided by
500 and then we have the height 49
divided by
281 and so instead of having
um x mean y I mean x max y Max we have
the center which is divided by oh which
is normalized and then we have the width
and the height which are also normalized
now putting this in form of code once
we're done with getting a specific
bounding box we could go ahead and
obtain the class name so you see we have
as usual I'll make use of our object
tree and then we find the name see here
here we have name and here's airplane
there's airplane there's person yours
person we're not going to be interested
in the post or whether it's truncated or
not or whether it's difficult or not
just interested in the name and this
brown and box just as we have seen
already
um that said we have
um our class name from this class name
we could create this class dictionary
which will use to convert the different
class names into a specific integer so
what this simple means is we're going to
convert airplane to zero bicycle to one
bird to two both to three and so on and
so forth so this is zero
um one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
um L this should be 10 yeah 11 12 13 14.
okay so we have airplane which is zero
and person which is 14 okay let's take a
look of that now getting back here you
see we're gonna we make use of this
dictionary where we simply have a class
and that's converted into an integer so
that's quite straightforward and then
now we have our bounding box which is
essentially X Min plus x max divided by
two that is we get the center this is
the center and then we divide by the
width
so that's it we have X Min plus x max
divided by 2 times width is essentially
the center divided by the width and then
we have the Y Center that's y mean plus
y Max uh divided by two that's the
center then divided by the height and
then for the width we want x max minus x
mean because to obtain the width to
obtain this width you simply take this
minus this to obtain the height we take
this minus this and that's it so that's
how we obtain
um the width and the height so here we
have x max minus one
um x mean then divided by the width and
then we have X Y Max minus y I mean
divided by the height and then we have
our class
um which is going to be
um an integer instead of say person or
airplane then once we are done with this
bonding box we now store this in this
rounding boxes list so let's create your
bonding
bonding boxes list there we go we have
the bounding boxes list and then now
um we'll return
oops will return
Bound in
boxes so that's it let's return that and
then there we go so let's run this and
then see what we get
now first thing you can notice is that
we have our four bounding boxes now take
note of the fact that we have the
classes zero zero and 14 meaning that we
have airplane and person which matches
exactly what we expect and then
when we get back to this image you see
35 divided by 500 and 215 divided by 281
we should have 35 divided by 500 and
then to 15 divided by 281.
okay so you see we have 0.07 and
0.76 okay so does it make sense and then
for the width for the width we had 18
divided by 549 divided by 281 so yeah we
have 18 divided by 500 and then 200
divided by 281
0.04 or 0.036 and 0.17
um 0.71 this should be seven one
oh let's get back here it's actually 49
divided by 281 and not 200. so this will
be 49 because the height is 49 so we
divide that and then it's here we should
have 0.17 okay so that makes sense so
that is it we have
um uh encoded mounting boxes
and now we're ready to produce our
outputs based on what was described in
the paper so in the paper
we saw that our output will be this 7 by
7 by 30 tensor
where each and every cell we have here
does each and every one of those 49
different cells because we have 7 times
7.49 will take values depending on
whether they have an object or not
now for a cell like this one that's
actually matching up with this one where
there is no object will take values like
or would have a value of zero for the
object-ness meaning that there is no
object and then for the positioning
we'll have this here that's four zeros
and then for the class because there is
no object we'll have all zeros now we
have 20 classes so we'll go from zero I
would have 20 of this zeros and there we
go so you see we have 20 of this zeros
now we're gonna have the same for each
and every grid cell where we do not have
an object now you should be noted that a
grid cell like this one for example this
one here
um let's change the color this grid
cellular
stick this well let's get back
this grid cell here has actually No
Object because
we consider a grid cell to have an
object if the center of that object is
in the grid cell now although we have
the wing of the plane in this cell uh
given that the center of this plane
isn't in this cell we do not consider
that this cell has an object so here
would have exact same values we have
here so there is no object like this is
0 1 2 3 this is zero one so we'll go
zero one two three zero one so here
would have this exact same values all
zeros and with this with this with this
this and all these other cells now what
we'll be left with will be this cell
which contains the center of this object
this cell which contains the center of
this object this cell which contains the
center and this cell so we have four
cells which contain the center uh or the
centers of this four different objects
while the other
cells contain No Object
now we shall Focus only on this one here
so you understand how this outputs are
generated based on the bound and boxes
and this length uh this length here is
essentially the number of bounding boxes
so it's got it could be getting from
this Browning boxes so here we have
bound and boxes which is
um in this case here for this object is
actually what we have here that is with
normalizes value such that we have the
center X Center normalized y center
normalized we have the width normalized
the height normalized and we have this
class
now as we saw in the paper this isn't
exactly what we want so what we want is
a value which tells us the position of
the object with respect to that specific
grid cell so if we take off this here
let's take this off
and then we specify the center of the
center here is around this position here
your soul Center
we would find that base now on the paper
this position here has to be encoded
such that we have the this value based
off this origin so it's based off this
origin because we have a grid cell here
which is um this one so we have this
grid cell so I'll create the same grid
so we have here so it's based off this
and not base of this origin of the whole
image remember the image has its origin
and this grid cell has its own origin
now let's shift this isn't very clear
let's shift so that we have this full
okay so you see clearly now
um the origin of the image which is this
and the origin of this I create this
point here and the origin of the grid
cell which is this point and then we
have the center of the image which is
around this year so centers are on this
so the idea now is to obtain this
distance from this year
from well from this um origin to this
point and that's it so let's get this
distance
and this distance
so that's it we need to get the distance
from year to year and the distance from
here to your as of now we have our
center normalized with respect to the
whole image and if you want to normalize
this now with respect to a specific grid
cell we need to take this value and
multiply by the number of grid cells we
have so given that here we have 0.07
we'll take that and multiply by seven so
we have
0.07 times 7 which will give us 0.49
and then we'll take 0.75 0.75
times 7 which will give us about 5.25
now what this means is that the distance
from year to this that's in this
horizontal direction is 0.49 that's
approximately 0.5 and this makes sense
because the distance from year that is
origin to where we have the center here
of this object is approximately half of
the distance from here to the full cell
and then the distance from here this
origin going the horizontal in the
vertical direction to this Center is
approximately 0.25 so we go about 0.5
and then you're about 0.25
nonetheless after multiplying here the
0.07 times 7 we have 0.49 that's 0.5
that makes sense we have we also
multiply 0.75 times 7 that gives us 5.25
but this distance is actually only 0.25
so what we'll do is we'll take 5.25
modulo
um
one and we'll obtain 0.25 because the
distance from this origin to this Center
the center this is the center of the
object is
um
0.5 in this direction horizontal and
0.25 in the vertical Direction
now let's make this bigger so you could
see that even clearer what we're saying
is we have a center which is around this
and then we have this origin here the
distance from year to year
is about 0.5 of our cell and then the
distance from year downward up to the
center this distance
is about
0.25 of our cell and we've seen that to
compute this automatically what we need
to do is get this already normalized
values from here we already have this
normalized values we multiply them by 7
and then we compute the modulo of those
um we find the the outputs from here
modulo 1 to obtain this distances so
let's do
[Music]
um
0.49 modulo 1
it should give you 0.49 and then
5.25 modulo one
it gives you 0.25 so you see that now we
have this center with respect to this
grid cells origin and that's exactly
what we had in the paper
now diving into the code you see that we
are going to create this output level
which is essentially going to be a seven
by seven by number of classes plus five
that's
um 25 what number of classes 20 by 25
tensor
and then we are going to go through each
and every bounding box we have here and
then
put in the values corresponding to the
specific cells so again we have seen
that for all these different cells here
we have all zeros but for this cell this
cell this cell and this cell we have
um non-zero values or not all values are
zeros so let's concentrate on this one
as we said already so we have here uh
for beam range length that's for being
the range of the number of bounding
boxes we'll say that length is the
number of bonding boxes we have the
bottom box that specific button box
um this zero here is simply this
so this is X Center the center we
multiply by the split size multiplied by
seven so it's just like taking 0.07
times 7 that will give you 0.49 so this
is actually 0.49
if we are dealing with this bonding box
here and then for this next one is
essentially 5.25
so this is this times 7 will give you
5.25 now or one other thing we need to
do is we need to pick that specific or
the specific grid cell to pick the
specific grid cell out of all the 49
results because we have seven by seven
here this one two three four five six
seven one two three four five six seven
so we have 49 options we need to pick
um only one option and that's what we
are doing right here
so to do that what we need to do here is
we take this 0.49
and then
we convert it into an integer
or we simply round this down so rounding
0.49 down will give you zero and they
run in 5.25 down we give you five
so it simply means that we are going
um in the X Direction our horizontal
direction we add the zeroed position but
in the y direction we go to the fifth
position so this is zero one two three
four five and then in the acceleration
we're still at zero so that's how we we
get this here and then so yeah we'll set
zero five and then the output level
zero five just like remember we had this
output which is seven by seven by twenty
five this is one two three four five six
let's add this other one
um seven and then here we have seven so
we have seven by seven by twenty five
let's add this here
we have this this this
one two three four five six and then we
have seven
so essentially what we're saying here is
um zero five that's zero um and then one
zero one two three four five at this
position right here
for the first five values for its first
five values we would have one once
signifies that we have an object then
for the positions you see we have zero
point five four four nine modulo one
which is going to give us 0.49
then we will have 5.25 modulo 1 which
will give us 0.25 so now we're finding
its position with respect to this
um cell and then we have the width we
have the width here which is this bottom
box two because this is zero one two so
this is the width but remember from the
paper it's of what we need to have here
was the width of this bonding box with
respect to the whole image so what we
have as value here will stay unmodified
so that's it
um
0.036
0.036 and then for the next value is
0.17 0.17
so that's how we obtain the first five
values you see we assign this
values we have right here
now for the classes we have from five
right up to
um 25 so we have from that's five plus
this we assign the value of one now to
understand why we what we are doing here
remember that this bottom boxes uh or
this bottom box of value or index value
4 takes in this value 14. so what we're
saying is at the position 5 plus 14 we
want to assign a value one now remember
that we have this first five values
which tell us the objectness
or which gives us the object score which
gives us a position
and then the remaining 20 values will
tell us the class of the object so after
listing this we also have the class but
we we have 20 zeros see
so again we have this objectness right
here
we have objectness
we have bounding boxes and then we have
the 20 zeros now when we say 5 plus 14
it means I will get to the 19th position
um this is five plus
zero one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen so at this position here
we're gonna take this off
and then replace that
with a one so here we have a one meaning
that
um this year has an object
this is bottom box and that object is of
class person
so you see here we assign this value one
and that's it we output or we return the
output level uh recall that we've just
done this for this object but we have
four different objects that's for in
fact four different bounding boxes so
we'll do for this we'll do for this
we'll do for this and we do for this
that said at this point we could take
all this off and then carry out some
testing so uh we have this pre-process
XML which outputs this here so we could
do generate
generate
um outputs which takes in
pre well let's copy this here let's copy
this
based on your the output of this is this
bottom boxes and then scroll so you can
see that clearly and then we have the
length of that output
okay so that's it we have this output
and we have the length of the output
let's run this and see what we get
um this isn't defined let's run this and
there we go
so we should have something reasonable
from this you see we have this outputs
and if you check this out you see seven
by seven by 25 and then now what we
could do is we could say okay we want to
get
um zero that's zero
um
zero
so zero zero let's run that see what we
get
zero zero that's this cell right here
you see all its values all the values of
this so let's take all this off all the
values of this cell here are zeros which
makes sense now let's do
um zero five
zero five we run that you see we have
exactly what we expect here we have 0.49
we have 0.31 meaning that the distance
from here to the center is about 0.31
um yeah we have 0.036 we have 0.174 and
then we have a one at this position mean
that that's a person now if we go zero
one two well this is zero one two and
that Horizon the direction and zero one
two in the vertical iteration so this is
two two let's do two two and see what we
have we have two
um let's get back
two two
we should have an object there see we
have an object so we have here one we
have his volume box and then notice how
this is his class remember the airplane
the airplane as we had here was the very
first class so it makes sense that we
have a one at this very first position
so that makes sense so that's it we see
how we could generate our output from
this
um data set we've we've been given all
this XML files we have for each and
every image before we move on we are
going to do some slight modifications on
the code so here we no longer need this
length we have the bound and boxes then
we're gonna create this numpy array
instead of the tensorflow variable we
had before so this exact same
um shape as before still our output
level and then
we will get the length directly from
this Banning boxes so we have for being
range length of the bounding boxes
then to account for the fact that we are
going to have this
um computations bashed we are going to
add this three dots right here so we
have now our grid X computed similar to
what we've seen and then we have our
grid y computed still our i j garden and
then here again we add the three dots to
account for the batch
computations and so that's the exact
same code and then now we're going to
convert this numpy array into a tensor
so we use the the convert to tensor
method um in tensorflow so that's it we
run this
and we still have our same output
now to ensure that our validation set
doesn't get mixed up with the training
we are going to Define this set of 64
images which will be our validation
um set or which will make up our
validation set there we go we have this
vowel list and then the next thing we'll
do is we are going to copy as you see
here we're gonna copy or rather we're
going to move this files into this two
directories so here if you open this up
now you'll see we've we've created this
directory vial jpeg images which is this
and we've created a directory vowel
annotations which is this other one
which contain the validation set
um images and annotations and so that's
it so now we're going to create this
different lists here we have the image
ads and the XML pads that we have the
validation image pads and the validation
XML paths
um let's run this
you see we have 17 061 files for the
training and then 64 for the validation
and that's it again you should note that
this training images has already been
defined here we've defined training
images right here we've also defined
vowel images and round Maps so that's
where we're getting all this from and
that's how we obtain all these different
paths
now from here we're going to create the
tensorflow
um data sets that's the train data set
and the validation data set which is
essentially
going to be made of these different
parts which we've just created so we
make use of this from tensor slices
method and we put the image pads and the
XML pads and the validation pads and the
validation XML paths so let's run this
and then we could visualize our
validation data so here you see we have
this path
here that's our image path and then you
see we have this other path which is our
XML file so we have the image and it's
corresponding XML file
then now that we have our image paths
and our XML pads already making up our
data set
from this tool we could obtain the image
and the bottom boxes for the image all
we need to do is pass in the image path
in this read file method then decode
that red file and then we
go ahead and resize and cast the image
so let's take this off if we we actually
do the casting here so no need doing
that before resizing so as we're saying
we resize and then we carry out the
casting and we obtain our image from
this image path now for the bottom boxes
remember we looked at this pre-process
XML method which was already explained
here we looked at this method which
takes in our XML path or our file or
file name and then outputs the bottom
boxes so that's exactly what we're doing
here and so that's it now given that
this method that's a pre-process XML
method isn't made of only tensorflow
operations will need to make use of this
numpy function method where we are going
to pass in our function here
we specify the input which is the path
that's our XML path and then
we also specify the data type of our
output tensor which in this case is
float32 so this let's let's say this is
XML path and here we have XML path okay
so now we have the path and we have the
method we can now obtain the boxes
and then now we have our train data set
which is going to be redesigned such
that we have this here we have this
paths the image path and the XML path
which gets in here and then outputs the
images and the boxes so you see trend is
set we map and then we specify the
method which is a get image and bounding
boxes this we get the images and the
mounting boxes from the image path and
the XML path so now our Trend data set
is no longer going to give us the the
image path and the XML path but it's
going to give us the image itself and
the bound and boxes so let's run this
and then see what we get
there we go you can see we have this
image and then we have this
corresponding Mountain box in this case
we have just a single Mountain box
um
let's go ahead and write this
and then we check this out here
um there we go we have this output you
could see so you see we have this output
here and it's showing that we have an
airplane so if you check this out you
see we have
um the button box here and then we have
the class the class is zero so if we
scroll to the top you would find that
the class airplane was here so this is
the zeroed class which makes sense now
let's try out with some others well
um most of all those ones here have only
one object but there is this one at this
18th position let's keep let's keep that
and then
or break then we run this again and then
see what we get okay so this this
particular
um
image has several objects so we could
check that out
um run this okay so you see here we have
now many more objects and here we have
many many people actually you have 14
and this happens to be person so if you
if you have
um here yeah we have this well okay so
if you do classes well the the list is
classes so let's just do classes 14 and
we get the exact class we have the
classes 14.
and you should see you should have
person
okay so you see we have one two three
four five six seven eight persons and if
you get here you see we should have one
two three four five six seven eight
exactly what we expect and then we have
ten eight eight well this eight
this eighth year
and then after we check out 10 it is
Cheer so maybe it's this cheer okay it
is twice so we have a chair here and we
also have another chair and then 10 is
um let's check that out it should be
dining table okay see we have the dining
table we have dining table we have chair
chair and then eight persons
so now we have the image and it's
burning boxes the next thing we want to
do is have the image and its output
levels remember with our generate output
method which we had seen already here it
takes in the output boxes and outputs
the levels so let's get right here and
then you see we have this pre-process
method which takes in
um again this
image and this bottom boxes and then
right here we are going to output the
image see here just simply output the
image but for the bottom boxes we need
to convert this into output levels so we
make use of generating output method
which itself takes in the bottom boxes
and then we specify the data type of the
output tensor
um again we're using this numpy function
method right here because this generate
output isn't made of only tensorflow
operations so that's it we'll run this
and then
um there we go
our final steps now will be to
um match our data set and then Implement
prefetching so let's run that and then
we have our training and validation
data sets which have been prepared
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we are
going to build our own yellow like model
so from the paper we had already seen
that we have this initial conf layers
which are pre-trained on the imagenet
data set such that
they could be used to extract very
useful features from our input images
and then this
um conf layers were followed by two
fully connected layers
which were designed in order to adapt to
our problem of object detection
now given that we do not want to
um train this backbone here from scratch
on the image net data set we'll use an
already pre-trained backbone which is
the resnet 50. again we have
um the output Dimension defined as
number of classes plus 5 times B from
the paper B is given to be two we've
seen this already and then five because
we have the probability of obtain an
object and then for the remaining four
we have the bounding box
so we have two of this
um bounding box predictions that's why
here we have two times five ten plus the
number of classes which in our case is
equal to any
now we Define this number of filters to
be 512. so that's it from here we have
our full complete model you could take
this off you see that we have
um a pre-trained resnet which is a
backbone or a base model and then we
follow this up with several conflictors
similar to what we have here in the
paper and then
we have the global average pooling which
is
what is given here in the paper
now one thing we should note about the
average pulling
is the fact that when we have inputs
let's say we have this
um seven by seven then by let's say five
so we have one channel
um two three four and then five so let's
suppose we have seven myself my five
input now after going through the global
average pooling what we will have here
is
the averaging of each and every value or
let's say pixel in
each and every channel so for this
channel for example we will have one
representative value for this channel
we'll have one representative value
which is the average so for this we
would have the average this would have
the average and this would have the
average so we average all these values
here
and the problem with this is
information about object position is
lost and so instead of using this
um average pulling it's preferable to
use the flattening
and so what we'll do is we'll take this
off from here and then I will have
flatten okay so once we have that just
with the paper you see here
we have the fully connected layer which
is this dense layer right here and then
this other fully connected layer so we
have that and then we reshape
now they should be actually split and
let's take all this here
copy and paste so split
by split
by split or split by split by output
Dimension so seven by seven by Thirty so
this is now our model
you can see we have a total of 53
million parameters totally trainable and
23 non-trainable that's from our
um resnet we are going to get into the
YOLO loss so here we have this yellow
loss method which takes in our y true
and Y bread where this is our Target Y
and then this is our predictions now the
yellow loss we have here
will be an implementation of what we
already discussed from the paper and so
it's made of four different parts the
first part is for the coordinates
the next part
is for the object
the next new object
and then finally we have the
classification
so we have those four different parts
now we're going to start with this first
part here we're going to start with the
object so
in this case we shall penalize the model
for not detecting an object at a
particular cell
and that's why you see here we have this
one obgij which denotes if the object
appears in cell I and
this J right here notice that here we
don't have a g here we have this J
denotes the fact that the Jade bound and
box predictor and cell I is responsible
for that prediction
now if we take a look at this figure
right here where we have split this
image which is actually 224 by 224 into
seven different parts so it's basically
now seven by seven
grid cell image and each and every grid
cell as we have seen has its own
predictions now uh if we specifically
break this
um grid cell right here so let's pick
this one as you see we've picked this
now we have two outputs or two possible
outputs we have the Y true
y true
and then we have the Y predicted by the
model
now you'll notice that if you count this
it's going to be a total of 13 and this
is going to be a total of 18.
as I've seen already this first year
represents whether we have an object or
not the next four which is all in green
is the
position of the object the image and
then this other eight specify the class
of that object
now before we move on you should note
that when we first recorded this section
on the YOLO loss we were working with a
data set with just eight classes
but since we now dealing with the Pascal
views he did a set with 20 classes our y
true will look instead like this so now
we're gonna have this additional 12
um values here and this additional 12
values here so
um instead of having 13 18 as with eight
classes now we are going to have 25
and 30. so it's like 13 plus 12 and then
um
18 plus 12.
nonetheless this doesn't change much on
our yellow loss method so wherever you
have
eight classes you should consider in a
specific case of the Pascal VOC data set
we're dealing with 20 classes now we had
also seen previously that although we
have this white rule which has this 13
um different values for each cell this y
bread has actually 18 values because we
have two possibilities or two possible
positions of the object we have this
first possible position let's call this
B1 and then we have this other possible
bounding box which we'll call B2 so we
had already seen previously that we said
B to 2 because we have two possible
bounding boxes
and we also saw that even though our
model or even though our data was
designed such that the outputs were
seven by seven by Thirteen the model
outputs seven by seven by 18 outputs as
you could see here
and so when we have a loss function like
this where we are given the Y true and
the Y pred where the Y true is in fact
seven by seven by Thirteen and the Y
bread is seven by seven by eighteen
since we want to start with the
object part of our loss function which
is this part right here
our focus should only be on these two
grid cells this grid cell and this other
grid cell right here so we want to focus
only on this with cell and this because
these are the only two grid cells where
we have an object located now the way we
shall select this programmatically is by
gathering all those grid cells where the
target is equal one now our Target year
is simply
why true well we've selected only this
object score so um if you look at y true
here and if we pick this object score
that coincides with this one we have
here so in the case where we have an
object we'll obviously have a one for
the Y true and
so when we say we're gonna pick all the
different cells of white bread where we
have a one at this y true level that's
this first for this first value of y
true it means that we'll now have y
print which is going to be all this
different cells where we have
actual objects
and then we're also going to do the same
for y Target or Y true so here we have y
bread extract and then we have y Target
extract which is simply taken or getting
all the positions where we have the
objects but in this time around for y
true so now we have y bread where there
are objects and we have y true where
there are objects and with this we can
now focus on only this two cells the
cell and the cell now let's take this
off and run this so that you could see
what this produces so we run that let's
let's print this out so let's print out
y red extract and let's print out y
Target
um extract well we could also print out
Target so well let's just print out this
this where right here so let's print
um
TF let's copy this would get this
so let's paste this out here there we go
and that should be fine so let's run
this and then now we'll test with some
inputs now the inputs we are going to be
using will simply be the exact same
coordinates we got from the
data set so here you have this
and then you have this where this year
corresponds to
um this other this car this vehicle
right here and then this one corresponds
to this other vehicle now we had seen
already how we could use generate output
method to produce our y true or our data
set value for y or the output so once we
have y true we are going to um
add an extra Dimension now we have y
true ready then for y bread we'll just
generate this random values and then
what we'll do now is for this specific
um values or for the specific cells
that's one four and three two we are
gonna put its own values
you'll notice that here we have 18
different values where here we have the
probability of having an object we have
the position one two three four there we
go we have the position the problem is
having an object we have a position one
two three four this is one two three
four here and then the for this rest
here we have
um the class or
the different class probabilities now
you could do the same for this other one
we have this and then we have one two
three four okay so there we go so this
is what we have as our y bread so we're
supposing that the model predicts this
and then this is our y true remember we
had already seen that this y true here
would produce
uh data sets outputs so now let's run
this let's run this and then run this
and then see what we get okay so there
we go you could see
um from here we have
all the different positions where those
Target value is equal one so that's what
we printed out here and you could see
clearly that we have
um one four and three two
now the zero year is simply because this
is the first batch value now um that's
it we have this one four three two for
the next we have wipe red extract so
wanna extract only those values where we
fall in this um grid cells now you'll
notice one thing that you have
0.90.47 0.31 which coincides exactly
with this
and then we have the sort of one 0.3
0.01 which coincides exactly with this
and so clearly we are only focusing on
the models outputs where we have actual
objects from
um our data set so we've we've picked
this here and we've picked this
and then now we're ready to compare what
the model produces at this positions and
what was expected which is why true now
so this is why pred and then this is why
true we're comparing only at this two
cells you see here we have two two now
what if we suppose that we have only one
object so if we have only one object
what we'll do is we'll take this one off
let's run this again
and you see now that we only have one
which is peaked so let's get back and
run that
and there we go so you see we we've
picked this uh we've picked this cell
and this other cell and we're ready now
as
um this described in the paper to
compare the different probabilities
calls with one another so we just simply
have to subtract this and that would be
good for this
um part of our loss now if we only had a
single bounding box prediction like here
if we didn't have this so let's suppose
we had only this and the Y true only
this then what we'll do is we'll take
this one minus whatever value we have
here and then we'll subtract so if y
plate is one and Y true is one we'll
just have one minus one we'll subtract
that and then we Square it exactly as we
have in the paper right here you see we
have on the object score minus the
target object score and then that
squared and from here we add this to all
the other um positions or all the other
objects at different grid cells that's
why we have this summation anyway it's
in this already so
um getting back here now that we
actually have two bounding box
predictions as you could see we have B1
and B2 what we'll do is we'll take
whatever value we have here and then for
this let's let's wipe this off
and wipe this off let's say this is a
dash this is a dash and then this is a
dash or some value let's let's call this
Lambda and uh we'll call this Lambda
what we'll do is we'll take this one
minus
one of the stats I add a Lambda one
let's if this is Lambda one and this is
Lambda two
so we'll have 1 minus Lambda 1 or would
have 1 minus Lambda 2. and the way we
shall pick between Lambda 1 and or
Lambda 2 is by looking at this
coordinates right here this positions
so if this bound and box we have here is
closer to this other bounding box that's
a true bounding box then we'll pick
Lambda one but if Lambda tools bound and
box does this is closer to this true
bounding box then we'll pick Lambda 2.
so that's how we do the picking
and the way we would compare this
bounding box with this and then this
other bound inbox with this is by making
use of the ious course so let's take
this off
and suppose that we have this input
image let's take all this off to uh we
have this input image and then we have
this bonding box so let's see this is
the true bounding box here
this is our true bonding box
and then we have this bonding box B1
which is something like this so let's
say here we have a Lambda 1 and we have
his coordinates so we produce something
like this
um let's change this color let's say we
have something like this see see we have
something like this so this is what uh
we're getting from this one year and
then we have this other bonding box
where we have maybe say something like
this
now in this case because this year let's
get back so we differentiate between the
two bottom boxes uh let's redraw this
here and then we suppose we had this
okay so because this green mounting box
is closer to the red bottom box we are
going to pick Lambda one and simply we
are going to take this into
consideration we're not going to take B2
into consideration when Computing uh
object-ness
um part of our loss
and so getting back to the code at this
point we have to subtract 0.
[Music]
um
nine
with one that we have here
or would subtract
um this is one two three four zero point
eight
and one so we have we actually have this
R this and the choice between this and
this will depend on this coordinates and
this coordinates
but then uh IOU method is designed such
that it actually takes in pixel values
so what that means is we could design
our IOU method which will take
the center
and the width and the height of these
two boxes let's say we have this this
box and this other box or this rectangle
lens of the rectangle we take the center
of this it's width its height we take
this other ones Center is with its
height and based on that we compute the
IOU score
but the problem we have in here is that
what we get here is not the pixel values
what we have here is
this pre-processed
values which we had seen already and so
if we have the center here no you could
read that from here if we had the center
uh which is at position let's say 43
that's 43 well let's let's fix this to
this we have 46 140 so we have this
Center which is at around 46 140. now we
have well 46
um take this off we have 46
140.
if you focus on only this first
coordinate year
then
would have 46
modulo
which will give us 12.
already 14. let's get back this will
give us 14 and then now this 14.
yeah we'll move to the next step 14
divided by 32 would give us 14 divided
by 32 we give us 0.44 so we would have
0.44
and this is a percentage occupied
um in this grid cell remember with to
obtain this coordinate or to obtain this
value from the original
um Center value of x would have to make
sure that we get this position of the
center
with respect to this grid cells Center
which is right here so this distance
from year to year is about 0.44 as we've
just calculated and that's exactly what
YOLO takes in
but since now we need to get back to
this original values from these values
we used to train because we need to be
able to compute the ious course between
a given box and some other box then what
we'll do is now reverse this process so
we are going to go from what we get here
like for example this value
back to this value 46.
now if you're wondering why we picked 32
right here you should note that uh this
image is 224 by 224 and if we divide 224
by 7 you would have 32 so each cell the
decision from year to year is 32 from
here to us 32 and so on and so forth so
if from here to this point here is 44 or
rather 46 then if you want to get this
remaining distance you just need to do
46 model or 32 to have this remaining
distance in here and then you divide
this Distance by 32 to obtain the
fraction of occupied by this distance in
this full
um grid cell
so with that we are going to also repeat
the same process for this height
coordinate so this is a center X and
Center
um y we will take 140 modulo 32 we
obtains value divided by 32 we now get
this fraction occupied from this year to
the center
we've gotten this already this is 0.44
well we could also get this Y and so
that's how we we obtain this um
fractions we have here anyway we've seen
this already but now what we're trying
to do is get back from this to a value
like 46 or from this to a value like
140.
now you should be noted that for the
width and the height it's going to be
quite easy because remember when
designing this or when obtaining this
what we had simply done was we took the
distance or we took the width of this
and divided by the image width so if we
take this and divide by the image width
then to obtain the original width all we
need to do is multiply by the image
width so if we had originally let's say
let's say this width was originally 20
for example then to obtain what we have
here this width and this height
will take 220 20 divided by 2 24. we get
some value let's say approximately this
is like one on 11 something like that so
it's like one on eleven uh let's say
approximately
0.11 okay so if you have 0.11 then now
to obtain 20 from this we just take 0.11
times
224 so that will give us back 20. so
that's how we reverse this is easier
compared to this where we need to go
through all this two steps before
getting back those original values and
again the reason I want to get this
original value is simply because I want
to be able to compute the io between a
given amount and box and
um this two bounding boxes here so it
could make the choice of whether to say
one minus Lambda 1 or 1 minus Lambda 2.
now let's dive into how we'll move from
0.44
0.375 it's actually
0.375 to
46 and 140.
[Music]
so the first thing we'll do is we'll
simply multiply this 1 4 by 32. now 1
will become 32 and 4 will become 128 and
this will take us from this origin right
up to this position so this is what we
will be found at this point here at this
point
you have from year to year is 32 we've
already seen that each grid cellular has
a size of 32 so from year to year 32
from year to year is 128 because we have
32 64
um 96 and then
128. so you see where we're already
getting close to the
um center of our object and so that's
why we have this risk killer right here
we have this
um rescaler
which is governed by multiplying this
values where the target equals 1 by 32.
so all the positions where the target
equal one will multiply by 32 and so now
let's run this and you see that we have
32 128 and for 3 2 we have 96 64. so for
this other object here for this object
we have
um one two three that's 96 and then 64
is one two so we are at this position
we're now left to get to the center
Center should be around this year
and you were able to do in this first
step now the next thing we want to do is
get rid of this batch here this batch
Dimension we don't need that so we'll
just have 32 128 96 64 and then we'll
add two zeros for the width and the
height so here's width and height well
this is X Center and Y center now to do
this we are going to Simply take off the
batch so you see we start from one we
take off the back Dimension which is not
considered a zeroth index we take that
off and then we add two zeros so here we
just add this to zeros now the the
number of
lines we would have would depend on the
length of our risk killer if our
scalar's length of two as in this case
then we'll have two by two
um a two by two Matrix which we are
going to concatenate with
um this rescaled outputs so essentially
we had this here we have this 32 let's
rewrite that when we take only this
first index all from the first index to
the end we have 32 128
and then we have uh 96 64 and then we
concatenate that with a matrix which is
two by two where we filled all those
with zeros and so now we have
this here which represents x y and this
height uh or wheat and height the next
thing we will do is we are going to take
this
Target coordinates know that we take
from one to five so it's essentially x y
w and H and then we'll multiply by 32 32
224 to 24. now let's explain why we
choose to multiply by all this so let's
suppose that you have for example 0.44
you know this is 0.44 right here and
then you have 0.375 for y or for the
center now taking 0.44 and multiplying
by 32 will give you this distance from
year to year in pixels so if you have
0.44 times 32 you should have 14. now
remember that to have 0.44 you have 14
divided by 32 and so now to get back 14
you simply have to do
um
0.44
times 32.
and that's exactly what we do here you
have this 32 times
um 0.44 and then you have 32 times 0.375
so once we have this first two now you
have the the width the height and the
width where you have
um the values multiplied by 224 and 224
which makes sense because as we've seen
before to obtain the width and the
height we divided by 224 and so now to
get back to the original width and
height we need to multiply by 224 so we
essentially having this here multiplied
by the coordinates or Bound in box
coordinates
now the reason why we're repeating here
is simply because we could have
um several objects now in case we have
two objects so we'll just repeat this
twice and carry out the same calculation
for the two different objects and this
repeats here where we specify the length
of the risk killer the line of scale is
equal to so this premise also repeat
twice
so that's it for the Target where we've
um taken this value this values because
this is one this is zero one two three
four and so we go when we say one to
five we're taking one two three four so
taking this this this and this
multiplying by 32 for this
multiplying by 32 for this multiplying
by 224 for this and this by 224 and
that's how we obtain this distance from
year to year in terms of pixels so from
year to year we get the distance and
then now
um we could also repeat the same process
for the other two predictions we have
for the prediction one and then we have
the prediction two preparation one we
simply do the same you see here this but
the difference is why prep and just wipe
red unlike yeah which is white Target
still have the same calculation and not
how here we go from six to ten because
this is one to five
and then this is 6 to 10 for bounding
box two so that's the only difference we
have here and then we would get the red
one and press two
so at this point for this object here we
know the distance from the origin right
up to the nearest
um
cell which is this distance in this case
is 32 we had seen that already and then
we also notice distance from here to
um the center of the object in terms of
pixels and that's what we just
calculated and that gives us about 15.21
so we have now 32 and we have 15.21 so
it means we have the center or the
distance from here to the center in
terms of pixels now for this 128 you see
we're going to go from here to here we
know that this is 128 and we also have
this distance from year to year which is
10. so now we could add this up for the
width and the height we've simply taken
uh what we had and then multiplied by
224 and that's what we've had so we
don't need to do any modifications here
now you'll notice now that because we
have this we could add this with this
this with this 0 with this zero with
this and then we could get uh our output
now which will be this width
and the all right at this center with
respect to this origin and the width and
the height with respect to the full
image
now to make it very clear let's let's
consider we had only one here so let's
take off this prediction and then take
off the sort of prediction and suppose
that we had only one object so you could
see on that very clearly you see here we
have
um 96 64. well this should be on the
other because we took this one off
um we should instead take this year off
oops this should be the one taken off
okay so let's run this again and there
we go so you see here we have 32 128.00
we have 15 10 28 52 where we will take
now 32 plus 15 and then we'll take 128
plus 10 we'll take zero plus this zero
plus that and that gives us the the
width and the height and also the center
and then for the predictions we will
take this plus this and then we'll take
this plus this take this plus this this
plus this and that will be it so finally
we'll be able to obtain the bonding
boxes in terms of pixels for the Target
for and for the two predictions
so finally now we are going to take what
we had here and then add with this other
one target uh this upscaler one and
target of scalar two so let's run this
so you could see the outputs
uh there we go you see we have now 47
we've taken the 32 plus that um around
15 and we've had 47 138 this this we've
had this this this this this and then
this so we now have this Burning boxes
in terms of pixels
so the next step one follow is actually
compare this box with this and then
compare this box with this and then see
which of these two are actually closer
to this
now one thing we did while designing
this wire press was to ensure that the
first one this one was going to be the
closer one because you you could see
here 47 47 they are actually almost the
same
um
values so that when testing you'll see
that this one is closer so to compare
this we will need the I or use car and
to compute this IOU let's consider this
simple example where we have two boxes
this V1 and B2
now the IOU as we saw already is simply
the intersection over the union so we
have to compute this it's going to be
this
year intersection
divided by the union so it's essentially
um
this region as we've seen already
divided by all this including this
intersection region so it is
um this divided by this
now starting with this intersection what
we'll need will be this year this
coordinate year and also the Sony this
position and this year so the way we're
going to get this point is by starting
by getting this point this point here
this point this point and this point but
remember that we actually dealing with
the center and the width and the height
so we are not having the X mean y mean x
max y Max and X Min y mean x max y Max
values by uh past in year what we pass
in here is what we actually received
there is the center
the width and the height now the first
thing we have to do is to convert those
coordinates given to us in this form of
Center width and height to one in which
we have this x mean y mean and this x
max y Max and to do that we have this
piece of code right here now first thing
you have to note is the fact that we
have
um 0 1 2 3 where this represents our X
Center y center width and height now if
you want if I'm given this year X Center
y center to obtain this position x mean
y mean it suffices to take for example
this x c which is this distance from
year to year and then subtract it or
take away half of the width from it
because from year three years of width
and then from year to years half of the
width and if we take XC minus half of
the width then we get back to this
position
and now if we take YC minus half of the
height then we get this position here so
at the end of the day we get back to the
origin
obviously of this specific
um box so if I want to get back to the
origin of the specific box which happens
to be X Min y Min I need to take XC
minus half of the width and Y C minus
half of the height and so you see here
we have this is XC this is X we've seen
this already minus half of the width the
width is two see the width half of the
width that you see we divided by two and
then x y c which is this
minus half of the height see three here
so that's what we do to have x mean
y mean
and now if I want to have x max y Max
then we have to take XC plus half
of the width and then y c plus half of
the height and that's what we do here
just simply replace and put the plus and
that's fine so that's how this box is
now uh this box one is converted to box
one to you where we now have x mean y
mean x max y Max and we'll do the same
for this second box now once we have
this The Next Step
will be to get this coordinates here
now it happens that if we want to get
this x mean because remember this is the
intersection now this intersection forms
another box now to get this year
it suffices to compare this
X Min y mean and this other X-Men
Wyoming so we take the X Min y mean of
B1 and the X mean y mean of B2 and look
for the maximum between the two and this
is maximum order one which is right most
because our origin our origin is at the
top left corner so increasing is this
direction increasing this reservation
decreasing this in this direction and
this direction so when we say maximum
of this and this then we're looking for
the one which is in the rightmost
direction so when we comparing here you
see we're taking the first two and the
first two here so we're comparing the
X's
and
um x mean y means actually so when we
compare the X and Y I mean we get the
one which is maximum and that's the one
which will play the role of the x-min of
this intersection
um rectangle which will form there and
then for the
x max y Max we need instead of minimum
so we need the one between these two
between this and this we need a one
which is to the left which is left most
so that's why we insert take the minimum
and we compare the last two and this is
x max y Max as you could see and then
that's how we obtain this position and
this position for this intersection
rectangle now once we've gotten that
that's X Min y mean x max y Max for this
intersection the next thing we want to
do is actually compute the width and the
height so that we could multiply and get
the area of this here now to get the
width and the height it's quite simple
we just need to take uh we need to
subtract this simple because here you
have let's let's write that again we
have x mean y mean
um x max
y Max so you just take X M plus x max
minus X and then you multiply by
um y Max minus y That's all so this is
the width and then this is the height
take this minus this times this minus
this that's all so that's what you see
is which is actually done here you see
we've done the subtraction
from here we've done the subtraction and
then we now multiply this two
and that's how we get the area the
intersection
um area now once we have the
intersection area the next thing we want
to do is obtain the union area so we
take the box one
you see two is the width
and box or one again the height
multiply the width times height we have
this area
take for the box two we times High we
have this area
now we add these two areas up you see
here we add these two areas up we remove
the intersection because we want to get
um only this and not we do not want to
add this twice because when you
calculate this area you already have
this and when you see calculated area
you still have this so you want to take
off the intersection because it's going
to be completed twice and then uh we now
have the
full Union and so now we have
intersection divided by Union and that's
it so once we have the intersection
divided by union now we will be able to
compare this with this and this and so
now in order to compare this uh
different boxes would have the target
box compared with thread the second
prediction and we also have the target
uh box compared with the first
prediction box
well before doing this we could actually
print this two out separately so let's
print this
um one out let's do a TF print
um second
box that's comparing the target with the
second box
um let's have that there and then we'll
compare the target with the first box so
let's print now first box
there we go we have now red one okay so
that's it we'll run this before having
this so you better understand what we're
doing here so let's run this
um let's take this off
we could take this off
and then run this
you see that with the second box we have
0.16 and with the first box we have 0.93
which makes much sense because when you
look at those predictions
the first box looks much more similar to
the Target
as compared to the second box which is
this one so it makes more sense that the
first box
um has a higher IOU score
now applying the tensorflow matte
greater method will be able to have this
Boolean output which tells us whether
this second prediction is greater than
the first prediction or the IOU between
the Target and the second position is
greater than the IU between the first
and the target so
um given that in this case for example
this IOU between the first and the
target is greater than the IOU Between
the Bread 2 and the target then this
will output false and since this will
output false casting this to an integer
will produce an output of zero
and the zero will simply mean that
between the two options that's the first
output and the second output this is
actually the first output
and then this is the second output or
second bounding box between the first
and the second bonding box this is the
one which has which is closer to the
Target and that's exactly what I want to
have here so there we go we have this
output zero now let's
um include this other example so now we
suppose that we have two objects this
object and this object
um by adding this we've added this other
one here which happens to be this object
then we'll uncomment this part and then
see what we have for the mask
so there we go you see we have 0 1
meaning that for the first object that
is this object here
it is
this
second box which is this one here which
is closer to the object or to the Target
and then for the second box then for the
second object here it is this first
which is closer now let's let's
interchange this let's take this off
here and paste out here and then take
this from here
and then paste out here and see what we
get take this off and add a comma right
here so now because this one here will
be closer we should have this
um one been picked so we should have one
one now let's run this and see what we
get see we have one one and you could
see that from here the second boxes have
higher IOU scores compared to the first
boxes okay so now we have the bounding
boxes which are closer to the Target
like in this case we know that B1 B1 is
closer to the Target as compared to B2
so the next thing we need to do now is
get Lambda 1 and Lambda 2. and then from
this Lambda 1 Lambda 2 choose
um Lambda 1. now let's start by getting
Lambda 1 Lambda 2 is going to be quite
easy all we need to do is pick this
zeroed value and this feed value
remember this is 0 1 2 3 4 and then five
so this is a fit so that's why you see
we picked this so this is the
probability
of having an object for B2 and then this
is that for B1 in fact this is Lambda
two and then this is Lambda 1. so we
concatenate this and then we rearrange
this by transposing so let's run this
and see what we get there we go as you
could see we have 0.9 and 0.8 that's it
and then we have 0.3 and
0.98 and so what we'll do now is based
on the mask we'll say okay for the first
value which is zero it means that we are
going to take this one
instead of this so we're going to take
this probability instead and then move
into the next position
or moving to the next object we are
going to select the value number or this
um first index or this first or the
second value so we'll skip zero and then
we'll pick one so for the first one this
is our Lambda one we picked and then for
this other one Lambda 2 will be picked
remember that if we
um change these positions then we'll
pick Lambda 2 for this one and Lambda 2
for this one because this will be one
one so since this is zero one we'll pick
Lambda one for this first object and
then for since this is one year we'll
pick Lambda two for this other object
so now to do that programmatically we
are going to gather all this
um
Lambda values that's this probabilities
here based on the mask so doing that
you'll see that we'll be able to pick
those values of Lambda corresponding to
those bounding boxes with the
higher iOS course with respect to the
targets so we've seen how uh when given
this let's let's take a single example
so let's comment this again
we'll comment this and this
will run that we've seen how we're able
to take
this two bounding boxes that's this
button box and this autobottom box
and then from this pick the one with the
higher IO score and hence pick the
probability
which we are going to use to subtract
from one so now we know that we will
have 1 minus 0.9 now let's reverse this
let's reverse this again
um or reverse this take this off and
then we paste this out here and then we
take this off
then we paste this here okay so let's
run this and then see what we get you
see now we have 0.8 that we've picked
this other one instead because this
bonding box is
um having a higher iOS call respective
Target as compared to this autobarning
box so this is how we are going to pick
the bound and box which we are gonna use
for computing the objectness part of our
loss
okay so finally now we just need to
compute the difference between what we
have here that's in this case Zero Point
um eight for example let's let's get
back so we have what we had originally
which is going to be 0.9 so the
difference between 0.9 and one so you
see here we have once as you could see
the length is based on the riskeller so
since we have only one object this is
going to be one so one minus
0.9 and that would be it now this
difference method we have here has been
defined is basically the square of Y
minus X so we take two subtract find the
square as Define the paper and then we
have this reduce some method to get a
single value so that's it we run all
this and we could now print out our uh
object loss so we have print object loss
there we go let's run that and
you'll see where we have 0.01 you see
that that's quite small because 0.9 is
close to 0.1 now let's just modify this
and say okay let's say 0.09 see that
it's going to be having a higher loss
you see that we have higher loss now
that's it so that's what we do now you
see that no matter what we do here even
if we put your 1.0 we will never have a
loss of zero here and that's because
it's this one which is used to compute
that loss we are now going to move to
the no objectness part of our loss which
is this year and it's kind of similar to
this calculation but the difference is
that now we focusing on those regions
where we do not have objects
so unlike gear where we focused on this
here this cell
where there's this object
and this other cell
what we'll do now is we'll be focusing
on all the other cells except for this
and this one and this one
so as you could see we get all the wire
threads We Gather all this
um predictions where the target is zero
that is simply where there is no object
so let's print this out let's print out
this
um different positions where we Have No
Object and the corresponding predictions
here we have TF prints y red extract so
um this is seven by seven meaning that
we have 49 different cells right here
now two cells have objects and the
remaining four to seven do not have
objects so let's run this and see what
we get and there we go here's what we
have so you could see clearly from here
that we have
um all these different cells and let's
do print so we could get its shape
um there we go let's run that you can
see this is actually 48 now
um that's because okay so that's because
we have only one object so if we have
two objects
two objects oops let's get back
um
we have two objects so let's run this
again and see what we get okay so you
see now we have 47 cells where there is
no object so that tells you that
um out of the 49 we have two where
there's an object
and then this wipe it extract here now
contains all this
um score and bounding boxes
you could see from here that this is 47
by 10. so let's get to the bottom you
see 47 by 10 because
um for each and every one of this we
could take this off from here we'll make
this connection from
um a cell where there is no object so
this cell for example
here
we have this 10 different
um
predictions and then now we will make
use of this to compute the loss so
obviously the no objectness are part of
our loss will be computed using this
Lambda and the slander so we'll take
this one or rather zero because we
expect it to be zero so this time around
our y true will be zero because when
there is no object like yours zero so
this is going to be zero minus Lambda
here minus Lambda one
um square plus 0 minus Lambda 2 square
so the idea is to ensure that those
probabilities equal zero when there is
no object and equal one when there is an
object
so getting back to the code you see that
we break this up into two parts this is
like getting the Lambda 1 or competing
with the Lambda one and this is like
accompanying with a Lambda two
so unlike with the object
um part of the loss where we're trying
to pick which of this
um was responsible for the prediction
here we just simply take this minus this
plus this minus this so
um
our Target is obviously zeros unlike
area where our Target was once so now we
have zeros and then we compute the
difference between our y Target here and
the Y print now you pick the zero for
this one and then we pick this five for
this other
um box right here so that's it we simply
find the difference or compute this
difference using this method which we've
defined already right here and then we
sum those two up to obtain our No Object
um loss so that's it let's print out oh
let's take off this
here
and then print out our No Object loss
we have no
object loss
there we go you see we have 110.
now we'll move to this next part that's
for the classification we will focus on
the objects class you'll see that we are
going to only compute this or get this
loss for cells where we have an object
you see here only where we have an
object and we do not
um care about which of the bounding
boxes is responsible because we actually
focusing on only the classes so the
instead of i j here we have just I
because we are not focused on choosing
or we are not interested in choosing any
specific bounding box given that it
doesn't really matter since we're
focusing on
um classes
so getting back here we have for object
class loss we have
the predictions and the Target now if
you check from your
you remember that the target will start
from five because this is zero one two
three four and then five
but for the predictions it will start
from ten so you see here we have
um zero one two three four five six
seven eight nine and then ten so we
start from ten right here so this starts
from five and this starts from ten now
we go from ten to the last and then
we'll go from five to the last and I
will simply compute the difference
between this and this so that's it we
also make sure that's where there's an
object so now you have this difference
and you obtain your class loss
you see that we obtain a class loss of
5.47
now we get to the last part of our loss
which is that involving the coordinates
which itself is broken up into two sub
parts this first part is just for the
center and then this other is for the
width and height
now this part is more similar compared
to this object that's part of the loss
simply because here we are going to
focus only on
cells where we have an object and only
on those bounding boxes which are
responsible for the prediction
so again we are going to gather all our
predictions here we got all our
predictions
where the target is equal one so simply
where we have objects
then now we combine the centers so we
see we go from one to three and then
from six to eight reason being that this
year because this is zero this is one
this is two so this year represent our
centers
and then when you have here this is
actually
um
six
seven
and this is representing the other
centers so this one is the center this
tool center so that's why you see we
take this and this and stack them up to
form our Center joint
then similar to what we had done already
with the objectness loss we are going to
only pick our given Center based on
whether it's that bounding box which is
responsible or not for the prediction
and again we're going to use this mask
remember we had seen this already
um previously with the objectness loss
so we had this already seen so the exact
same process we following year we just
want to make sure we pick in the
bounding box which is responsible for
the prediction and since we've computed
this mask already that's what we're
gonna do now let's let's print out
um
our Center joined
and then
let's print out the center print so we
see that we actually pick out only some
bounding boxes from
um the two choices we have Center print
you see here that for the first object
which is this we have this option and we
have this option now because for the
first object this is the first or the
zeroed index that's responsible you see
here and then for the second object we
have this option and this option but
because it's this one that's responsible
or the second bonding box or the or the
first index that's responsible we
actually picked this so you see that
this one is discarded and this one two
is discarded so we focus only on this
now for the Target we simply just pick
out this one and two so that's it so we
picked this obviously going from one to
three is simply taking one and then
taking two so we pick this and then now
we compare with
um whichever one of this is responsible
for the prediction and comparing that is
simply applying our difference method
so now that we're done with the center
we we finish with the center uh
that's actually this part here we're not
going to move to the width and the
height
so here is exact same thing with just
the difference that we're picking the
width and the height so now instead of
one two we're gonna pick three four so
that way you see we go from three to
five and then here we pick eight ten
well okay this is a prediction so
instead of picking this this we pick
three four so we have this
um let's pick this we have this three
four and then eight ten so that's what
we do here
we stack them up
we carry out the selection and then we
also
um get the target so we take this three
four see that and then we compute the
difference now remember that when
Computing this difference we have to
make uh take the square root so you see
here we have square roots
and since the square root takes in only
positive numbers we make sure to compute
the square root of the absolute values
so that's it print and size Target
and from here we've gotten the center
loss we've also gotten the size loss
this now forms our box loss and that's
it for all these different loss
functions we're not simply going to add
them up
now before adding up remember from the
paper we have seen that Lambda
coordinate is going to be 5 and Lambda
no object is going to be 0.5 we have
seen this already from here we have this
Lambda coordinate and this Lambda No
Object so that's it we we have this we
make sure when adding this up we take
this into consideration so let's run
this and then well let's print out a
loss so let's print out the loss
and there we go and that should be fine
we are then going to Define our model
checkpoint
well file path is this year then we're
going to see if only the weights we're
going to monitor the validation loss
um we're gonna obviously save the model
which produces the minimum or the
smallest validation loss and that's it
we'll set the base we save the best
weights only so we run that and then now
we move to the scheduling
here if the number of ebooks is less
than 40 so the first 40 ebooks we use a
learning rate of 1 times 10 to the
negative three uh between 40 and 80 we
use a linear 5 times 10 to the negative
4 and then after that we use a linear
rate of 1 times 10 to the negative four
so that's it I'll compile our model and
then we start with the training
now after training for your ebooks
you'll notice that the model starts to
overfit and so in the next section we
are going to treat our
use several techniques to help solve
this or resolve the problem of
overfeeding now we've been training for
over too many ebooks and you could see
clearly from the loss and the validation
or the train loss and the validation
loss that our model starts performing
well and at some point starts over
feeding as you could see here we have
the training loss which keeps dropping
it right here and then the validation
loss
um drops and then at some point starts
increasing so clearly our model is over
feeding
hi there and welcome to this new and
exciting session in which we shall be
looking at different strategies to
reduce overfeeding and in the yellow V1
paper some strategies were underlined to
avoid overfeeding they use drop out and
extensive data augmentation now a
Dropout layer with rate 0.5 after the
first connected layer prevents
quadaptation between layers and so yeah
you see that after this fully connected
layer we're gonna have the drop out and
we're gonna give it parameter 0.5 then
for the data augmentation the authors
introduce random scaling and
translations of up to 20 of the original
image size then they also randomly
adjust the exposure and saturation of
the image by a factor of 1.5 in the HSV
color space so that said we are going to
break up our data augmentation
strategies into two main category
Stories the very first category will
entail
modifying the pixel values without
modifying the positions of the different
objects so we could have something like
this let's click on edit right here and
then let's
um try to say brighten up the image you
see we could modify this like this so we
go from this initial image to this by
playing around the brightness playing
around with colorization and so on and
so forth so this first category as we've
said already entails just modifying the
different pixel values without any
change in position of any object we have
here and then for the second category we
could go from this image to this one
where you see that this flipping has
made this object position to go from
here to
um
this position right here
and now in the first case where we just
modify for example the image brightness
there is little honor updates made to
our existing code base but when we have
to modify the image such that the bottom
boxes have to be changed or the
positions of the bounding boxes have to
be changed like this one here or this
one which will go from here to year this
one year which goes from here to this
other one it means that we are now
updating this bounding boxes
and so we would have to write some extra
code for all these different
modifications now nonetheless it turns
out that when we work with a library
like argumentations stick this off when
we work with argumentations
all changes made in the positions of the
bottom boxes are carried out
automatically so you could see here we
have this input image with this dock
this tennis ball and this cut and then
after going through some transformation
like here we see we have
some transformation on this image where
first of all the image is flipped so you
see the dog moves to this other position
and then
the image also appears zoomed in so you
see that
um this card for example is now
um not as complete I wouldn't have the
complete cut as we had in this original
image
and so now we have completely different
bounding boxes this one for example
becomes this this thing is ball becomes
this this uh docs bounding box becomes
this so it becomes you can see that it
becomes larger as compared to the inputs
and so uh with augmentations as we're
saying you have this input bounding
boxes like you could see for the dock at
this position
2374 and 295 388 is automatically
converted to 149
69 like you see here 295
381. so here you just need to Define
your Transformations and then
augmentation make sure you have the
right bounding boxes as output
so now diving into the code as you might
have seen in some previous sessions
we're going to import
augmentations so that's the important
implementation we now move on to
integrate our transform you see right
here
we have this different transforms the
first thing we'll do is to resize our
images to 24 by 224 and then we'll apply
a random crop now this random crop is
applied such that the output image would
have a height or rather a width line
between 200 and 224 and a height line
between 200 and 224 so we could just
have this
um height or let's say height minus
20 or we could just say 0.9 percent of
the height
so we have that we go from that to and
then here we also have
um 90 of the width so we have 0.9
um of the width
take that off and there we go here we
have the width okay so what we're saying
here is as we've had already we want um
to randomly crop the image so we'll have
the image now our new image will have a
width which will fall in this range and
the height which will fall in this range
and then we want to have a probability
of 0.5 of applying this transformation
so
um if you want this transformation to
always be applied then you could always
set always
um apply to true if not you just have P
the other probability of applying to set
to 0.5 or maybe even 0.2 or say 0.8 it
just depends on you so that's it now for
the next we have this random scaling
here we specify the scaling limit we
have the interpolation type and then
again we have this probability then here
we have the horizontal flip so uh we're
gonna apply ours in the flip and
probability set to 0.5 now finally
because after doing this random crop we
will have an image which is not 224 by
224 it actually resizes back to 224 by
224 so that's it that's all you need
those are all our Transformations here
which we pass in this compose method so
it's basically a list made of this
transform this transform this transform
this and this now one additional term
we're going to pass in this compose
method is this bounding box parameters
and the reason why we need to pass this
is simply because unlike with um the
image classification with the object
detection we have bound and boxes which
are going to be modified so here we
specify this bounding box parallel so
take to consideration the kinds of boxes
we're dealing with and here you notice
that I will specify a format yellow
now getting back to the documentation we
actually have three formats we have the
Pascal VOC format augmentation format
cocoa format here yellow format let's go
VOC augmentations now it turns out that
in our specific case we actually dealing
with the yellow format not just because
we're building a YOLO model but because
the way we've normalized our inputs or
processor inputs such that we have our X
Center
y center width and height representing
our bounding boxes so if we had instead
x mean y mean with height would have
picked this so it's not it's not it's
not because of the name although it's
um actually coincides with the fact that
we're building a YOLO model but then as
we said
um we have in Accenture y center with
height and again this is normalized
notice here it's normalized so this year
is divided by the width this divided by
the height this is divided by the width
and then this divided by height remember
this is the width and the height of the
specific bound and box
which happens to be exactly what we have
seen when we're doing this year remember
we took the x mean what I mean we
obtained the X Center and then we divide
it by the width to the the y mean y Max
obtain the Y Center divided by the
height to the the width divided by the
total width to the height divided by the
total height so is
um the yellow
format we actually using right here
now again gets into the code you see we
have the format YOLO specified now here
we have those mean area set to 25 and
this mean visibility is set to 0.1
now to understand the concept of the
mean area consider you have this input
right here and then after carrying out
the transforms what you have is
um say this in this output here so we
have this output where the area of the
this box is
4344 pixels this is actually the cocoa
format so you'll find that the bottom
boxes will be different from the kind of
bounding boxes we have nonetheless the
area as we set after transformation is 4
344 pixels so clearly it's quite small
compared to the 23 892 pixels we had
already from this 132 times 181
um computation we had here so after
transforming this we obtain this right
here but if we set the mean area to 4500
it means that any box less than 4500 is
going to be omitted and so that's why
you see that when we specify this mean
area to be 4500 this box here disappears
so if you don't sell anything the Box
remains but if you set this then the box
is going to disappear and then we also
have the mean visibility so let's take
this here
it will set the main visibility to say
0.3 then if the output box which is this
box divided by the initial box which is
this
is less than or gives us a ratio less
than 0.3 it means that box is going to
be omitted and so right here if you take
this this area which is 688
um divided by 24 108 from this original
box here 24108
um you would have
0.286 Which is less than 0.3 so when you
see you see when you say 0.3 this box
disappear uh disappears so that's it
that's that's the
um idea behind the mean area and the
mean visibility
now we can actually leave those out so
let's just take this off and that should
be fine so this is it we have our
transform so we can run this
um there we go we have our org albumment
method which takes in the image takes in
the bound and boxes and then all it does
is it passes the image and the bounding
boxes into our transforms here and then
we obtain
the transformed image and the
transformed bound and boxes
so as we are seeing the schematic gear
we go from this image mounting box there
to this transformed image transformed
bounding box pair
so let's get back to the code we could
run this and then we have our pre our
process data method
which makes use of this um tensorflow
numpy function because actually here
those are known tensorflow operators
which we are calling
um especially here when you you make use
of augmentations it's
made of computations in numpy so we make
use of this method right here in order
to integrate that in our data pipeline
so here we specify the function of
argument the inputs image and running
boxes the output tensors here this one's
this two year the floats are actually
flow 32 so that's it so we run this and
we create our train data set so we could
visualize that
um you see for example here we have this
image let's write that image out so we
could see it we had
um output 1 and output two let's check
that out see here we have this oh no
modification was made so in order to be
sure that we make
um we'll see some change what we could
do is we could
um make sure for example let's let's
comment this random scaling
and then let's carry out let's make sure
the flipping is always done so we have
always
um
true
um set always
apply
set to true
there we go so we run that run that
again and we have output one and then
output two which hasn't flipped now one
thing you'll notice is also the fact
that this bounding boxes are changed so
let's copy this from here and then
um let's piss it out just here so we
could see that
okay so this is what we have before and
this is what we have after
now you see that this actually makes
sense because
um when you have this original image
when you have this original image where
you have something like this for the
bound and box oops
whereas all of that we have something
like this
and then uh when you flip it you see
when you flip it what actually changes
here will only be this X Center so if
your Center was around this let's say
isn't this around this then flipping
um
the X Center changes position slightly
and that's what we will notice here you
notice how this X Center changes
position just a little bit uh but for
the Y Center it doesn't really change
the width and the height Remains the
Same now let's play around with this
here so let's let's have this random
crop now
let's do this
um let's add this to always apply this
is always apply to true so we'll have
that oops would have always
um apply we set it to True run this
and
check out our output so here would have
okay we should have let's run this here
to have out two so we'll have out one
and then we have out two
thank you okay
now what we have is this and then this
you see appears
um somehow zoomed in anyways this
example
now shows us that we have let's take
this off we have this image which has
this bottom box here something like this
and this and maybe the center around
here and then now it's modified you see
um the the the
height gets modified and although not
too much actually the width doesn't
change well it changes just a little bit
now let's change this example so that we
could see this clearly
um this example isn't very
demonstrative of this transformation
process so we'll take maybe the second
um
wouldn't say do a skip so here we have
skip
uh yeah yeah then we break
um hopefully the second has maybe many
more objects or or it's a better example
actually let's check this out
uh okay so after flipping we expect to
have something which is looking
different from this
um okay so that's it let's take this off
for work with this example now let's run
this again
we have this year run this
there we go
we have that we have our output which we
obtain from skipping and then we get
back here and then we also skip so we
Skip and there we go two and then from
here we break
we run that
and then see what we get
now you could see from here we have our
output one let's also check out our
output too
there we go we have R1 and then R2
exactly as we expect see that now this
this example is much uh different from
what we had before and should be a
better way to demonstrate what goes on
um in augmentations so right here we
have this input
um boxes let's copy that
we have the input boxes
we're gonna paste it just here our input
boxes
take that off
there we go we have this output boxes
copy that and then paste right here now
before we move on notice the fact that
those classes are the same so class 18
and here's class 18 and if we get right
to the top you well with these classes
so let's let's say classes
um let's get 18 and see what we get it
should be trained
um from here we have well
here we have classes
classes 18.
there we go we see we have train okay so
that is it let's take this off now let's
um check this out we have our out one
you could see from here it makes sense
that the center is about
um 27 of the full width so this distance
is about 27 of all this distance so
that's it then this distance to is about
36 percent of all this distance
and then we have the width the width
which is about 0.54 or 54 of the Total
Image width let's change the color
there's about 54 percent
of the total width and then this is
about 71 percent of the total height
now after flipping
you see that this has a change let's
drag this now drag this this way
and we have something like this
take this off
you would see that this now the center
or this distance here the distance from
here to here is about 73 percent of the
full image see that Accenture changes
and then the for the for the height it
doesn't really change much or changes
very little see that almost the same the
width remains practically the same and
then the higher Mass also almost the
same but at least the idea here to show
that
um
after going through this augmentations
transforms augmentations permit us to
obtain this output Bound in boxes
which match up with the transformed
image
now don't forget to make sure you change
this back from always apply to
probabilities of 0.5 so that's it the
next set of Transformations would make
will be with tensorflow
and will make use of tensorflow image so
here we have this random brightness
random contrast
um we're going to leave out the random
crop for obvious reasons remember if you
have to do this random crop it means you
would have to write the code which
permits you also modify the bounding
boxes because when you carry out a
random crop the bounding boxes actually
change so
um that's why we're making use of
augmentation since it makes life uh it
makes life much more easy and then
um we use this we use this we carry out
no we're not carrying this out we carry
out no not this we carry out random U
um random saturation okay so this is
what we're gonna make use of you could
see that here in the code we have
brightness saturation contrast U and
then we finally carry out this clipping
by value to make sure all the values
slide between 0 and 255. now you could
always feel free to comment on comment
um any one of this um right here so that
said we again going to carry out this
pre-processing see we have that and then
um remember this is for the training and
then this is for the validation so
that's it we carry out this mapping we
batch pre-fetch and then you could check
out your
um outputs right here so let's say out
one out two
let's check out R3 here we go we have
out three well this should be let's go
to skip let's keep this
um skip
two and break okay so let's run that
again and see what we get R1 R2 and out
three out one out two and Out Three
well um since this was already bashed
we'll we'll maintain the tick so we'll
take the first we'll maintain this and
then here would pick out
um one
run that and there we go
we instead have this so this should be
two let's run that we have R1 R2 and
then out three
out one out two and R3 okay so you see
that this now appears uh much darker as
compared to this one so that's it we
I've seen how to carry out those
different Transformations or
augmentations but before we go on with
the training again one slide
modification will make is we'll replace
this resnet 50 with the efficient net B1
then we'll go ahead and compile the
model and restart the training there we
go train has begun
and after training for several epochs
here's what we obtained you could see
here that the loss the law the training
loss and the validation loss both keep
dropping you can see that they all keep
dropping
um up to where we have this
123 around this year so up to around
this our loss keeps dropping and then
um somehow increases slightly and
stabilizes around
128 so that's
why at this point we have to stop the
training and get the weights which
produced the lowest validation loss
and that's it for the section in the
next section we are going to test out
this model
either and welcome to this new session
in which we are going to dive into
testing out our Euro model which we
trained in the previous section
and to carry out this testing we are
going to make use of the Coco data set
and so now we'll pick a random some
images from this data set and test them
out with our model
now the first thing we'll do is load the
model so there we go we load the model
we're going to create this outputs
directory and then we'll specify the
path to our test images now let's dive
into this test method
um here we're going to take the file
path that's the test pass and then we
have this image on which we are going to
put the button boxes and the classes
then given that we are not
or we did not use opencv to load the
image previously we are going to go with
the exact same
um process we had already that is to
read the file we decode and then we
resize so this is what we had and once
we have this image we pass this into our
model now the output of our model will
be something like this so we'll have
this
um seven
by seven
by
dirty stencil
now remember that for a cell like this
one where there is no object we suppose
that this person here is an object a
cell like this one where there's no
object will have a zero for the other
first position and then for the next
position we'll have
um
this
for bounding box positions or bounding
box values and then we'll have another
zero and then we'll have four and then
we'll have now the 20
um values for the class now given that
there is no object here all this
wouldn't really matter and so that's why
we are only going to take the
boxes where
these two values this value and this
value is going to be greater than or
equal certain threshold which will
Define to be 0.25
so that said a cell like this one which
is the center of our object remember we
have this object here and we have this a
center so you would have this um
cellular represent the center meaning
that if we take this let's take its
values if we take this you would have oh
let's say 0.75
and then you have four values
representing this position uh always
Bound in box and then we'll have maybe
um another say zero point
um nine then we have four values and
then we have
um different values here for the class
and so the idea here is to get all these
different positions where we have values
greater than 0.25
now you should know that we could pick a
threshold of say 0.5 or 0.7 or 0.2 as
per have done
um and it really depends on how
this threshold affects the model
performance so we picked 0.25 because it
performs better than picking 0.5 as with
0.5 uh many objects were missed out so
that is it we move to the next we simply
just gather all these different outputs
that is we have the object positions
from here and then to obtain this
different outputs here
we'll take the output itself which is
all this and then based off the
positions we would get this outputs
so if we do here if from here we do we
print out the objects
um positions objects
positions and then below we print out
the selected
output that's here we have this
exception okay so let's run this
you find that for this
um image for example we have this
positions that is
um let's get back to this so it's
telling us that this is
and the position 4 3 we have an object
so we will go zero one two three four
and then zero one two three so an object
is found here for this um image we have
now the reason why we're having this
duplicated simply because it happens
that for this first position that's for
this first car there's an object and for
this other score there's also an object
you could see that from here that we
actually compared the zero position and
this fit position which is this 0.75 and
the 0.9 respectively
and now we could take a closer look at
this selected output you see that this
is
0.96 so here is 0.96
well it's for this position so we could
we could just take all this off so if we
take all this off all this here off
um this is 30.
you find that this which is 4 3 the
object for this uh specific image is for
um false at this cell for three and the
outputs uh this here
and you see the first position 0.96 then
we have the four for the bottom box and
then the next 0.9
um eight so it shows clearly that the
model is sure that there's an object
there and then from there we have this
four again and then now we followed with
this
um 20 different classes now
um just by looking at this just by
looking at this here 0.3 0.3 I'm trying
to look for the the one with the highest
value okay it shows clearly that this is
the class with the highest value
and so from this we know that there's an
object at this position
and that object belongs to this class
and obviously we have the bound and box
surrounding the object
so now that we've had this different
um values right here the next thing to
do will be to convert this bound and
boxes as this into
the x mean
y mean x max y Max format
which we are then going to use
um opencv to
draw this bounding boxes on the image
now we are going to go through each and
every object position which we've had
already from here you could see here we
have this object positions
um zero four three zero four three well
it's a duplicate so let's focus on just
a single or this single one so we have
um zero four three that's essentially
the position for three as we've seen
already and
um to obtain the output box which is
um this value this value and this value
what we'll do is we'll get that we have
the output and then we'll say output
position zero position is from the
object positions remember the object
position in this case is zero four three
So when you say position zero you're
taking zero
so here you have zero position one is
four position two is three
and that's how you select this um
specific output here now once you select
the specific output the next selection
you want to make is that of the bounding
boxes now when J is equal to zero here
you have zero times five is zero so you
go from one right up to zero plus five
that's five so we go from one up to five
obviously one up to five minus one so we
have one so we see this position one
here position two position three and
then position four so that's how we
select this here from our output and
then notice that given that we we have
um two different
um bounding box predictions you have
this year
so for the first one you have one to
five and then for the next time we get
into this Loop we have
um
um since this is one we have one times
five which is five five plus one is six
so we go from six
to ten
which now is this year this is six seven
eight nine well six seven eight nine
okay yeah six seven eight nine uh we're
going from six to ten minus one so
that's it so this is how we obtain the
output boxes
that's how we obtained this yeah of this
button boxes and then given that as we
said already we need to convert this
into this x-min x max y Max format
the first thing we'll do is convert it
into the X Center y center format or X
enter y center
um width height format which is
um what we do here now to obtain the X
Center from this year from this 0.53 for
example and so let's suppose for example
that this 0.53 is at uh the position
um o43 that's this well it's four three
so we go zero one two three four zero
one two three so we have this here
um around the center or 0.53 0.173 one
year we have this
and the idea is to obtain its value with
respect to this
um full image hide and image width so
first things first we know that the
distance from here to this position here
is simply
4 divided by 7 times
um 224
times 224 and that's simply because all
this is one two three four five six
seven so because uh the full image width
is 224 it means
um getting right up to this position
here is
um four and seven times two twenty four
which is in fact four times thirty-two
because 224 by 7 is 32. so you take this
year
and multiply by 32 and you get this
distance from here right up to this year
now to to account for the fact that we
have this 0.53 here 0.53 will take 0.53
times 32 because those four cell is 32
so 0.53 times 32 plus 4 times 32 so
um to obtain this distance we have 4
times 32
Plus
0.53
times 32.
now for the warm height because of the
for the Y Center because this is X
Center will still go zero one oh this is
one two three so we still have this here
again divided by 7 times 224 so it's
going to be 3 times 32.
Plus 0.17
times 32.
so that's it to to obtain the Y Center
we have the this position that's 3 times
32 plus 0.17 times 32 to find this
distance here so that's exactly what we
do right here you will notice we have
this
um plus one this post one is actually
from here this is post so post one is
four
which is
um
multiplied by 32 because this is this
plus one plus this output 0 times all of
this
times 32 so you have this
times 32 plus this output box zero
output box zero is 0.53 0.53 times 32.
so all this is just like saying we want
to have four plus zero point five three
and then all of this times 32 so that's
what we do here for the Y Center is the
same we have post two now this is it
year 3 times 32 plus
um output box one output box one is
um this 0.17
0.17
um times that's two remember we've got
output box from here
and the coincides with 0.17
so that's it we obtain X Center and we
obtain y center and the next thing we
want to do is obtain the width and the
height for the width and the height is
going to be easier because when um
encoding this we simply divided by the
complete width and the complete height
so now we'll simply multiply by the
height and then multiply by the width to
obtain the width and the height so
that's how we obtain this from here we
could now leave from X N to y center x
with Y width to X Min y Min x max y Max
now
um if you have a burning box like this
um let's say we have the center and we
know the width and the height to obtain
the X mean we could simply take this
Center minus half of the width because
this distance let's say this is the
origin this distance here
here is X Center if we subtract half of
this width then we'll have this distance
which will take us to the x mean
and then we do the same for the Y that
is we take this distance
right up to the center and then we
subtract the Y
um the y height that's the height we
subtract half of the height not not the
height but half of the height then we'll
get to this position that's why I mean
that's what we do here we have X Center
minus half of the width uh and then we
have y center minus half of the height
and then for the max we have X enter
plus half of the width so if you want to
get this position here we'll take this
plus half of this width which will take
us to this point here and then if you
want to have this or for the for the Y
then we'll take this distance
this distance plus half of the height
which will add up to this this point
right here so we have X Min y mean x max
y Max now be careful in case where the X
mean happens to be less than zero we
want to fix this to zero if it's less
than if the y mean is less than zero we
fix that to zero so we don't have
negative values if
um this is greater than the width we fix
that to the two width if if the Y Max is
greater than the height we fix that to
the height and so once we have this now
we obtain our final boxes that's x mean
what I mean x max y Max and then not to
forget the fact that we have some
classes so
um we are going to Simply get the class
with the highest probability score so we
just do this Arc Max and we make use of
the selected output remember the
selected output is
what we had already seen here
So based on this we are going to take
the last 20 values this year we get the
AG Max which happens to be this year and
then we get a class which corresponds to
this position so that is essentially
what we do right here we we we have that
position and then we we have its
corresponding class we make sure that
it's a string and then we
add that to our final box so that's it
for our final box we also need our final
scores we understand why we need to find
our scores later for now just take uh
the final scores we we make sure that we
have again you see if J is equal to zero
then here we have zero so we have the
selected output I
and we pick zero meaning that we're
picking this
and then if J is equal if J is equal to
one
then here would have one times five
that's five so that's a fit position
which is going to be this probability
Square so essentially we're getting the
probabilities scores for the two
um predictions I remember we had
actually we actually have two
predictions so we get the r
probabilities course and then we
um
bring them out so we see what this look
like
there we go as you could see we have
0.965 which makes sense this is 0.8
uh yeah we have 0.965 and we have 0.985
well this is because there's some
duplicates here so that's it then we
also see the final boxes you see the
class person C person person
now uh we're gonna see how to eliminate
this duplicate shortly and uh that's it
so for now we have
um understood how we could get from this
model's outputs to then be able to
obtain this final boxes and the final
scores
and now the next step will be to get
into this non-max operation so we have
uh maybe seen already the we looked at
the normal separation already in theory
now we'll see that with tensorflow is
actually very easy to implement this but
before implementing let's
um take a look at what it's all about
let's suppose we have an image like this
and then we have
um this object let's say we have this
object here and then we have some bound
and box
we have this bottom box remember for
each um cell we have two predictions so
let's suppose that our cell predicts
this and that same cell predicts again
another bounding box like this all this
for this same object now what we'll do
is with a non-max operation algorithm we
are going to compare these two
probabilities and say okay which one has
the highest probability
if it turns out that it's this one with
the highest probability so let's say if
this is 0.98 oops is let's say if this
is zero point
9 8 and then this one here is
0.96 and then this two are predicting
the same object then we are going to
discard this box so
Max suppression so we'll suppress this
box and we'll be left only with this so
that's how we're gonna also
um discard those duplications now
um going back to implementation all we
need here is just this um not Max
operation method we have here so we have
this number Max operation from
tensorflow image we specify the boxes so
we have these boxes here now note that
there are boxes from here included the
classes but we do not need that year so
we just as you see we pick the first
four elements that's essentially X Min y
Min x max y Max we pick this first four
boxes then we also make sure we send in
this course remember in the normal
acceleration algorithm we need this cars
to be able to discard certain boxes
which have uh or which are not the Max
uh scores which we do not have the max
course and which are predicting uh an
object which has already been predicted
by another box of higher score so that's
why we need to pass in the score here so
um essentially we pass in the boxes
passing the scores we want to specify
the total the maximum
output size yeah we'll just pick 100 we
we don't expect to have more than 100
but depending on your on your task like
you could have a task where you
generally have maybe say 150 objects to
be detected at once in that case then
you need to increase this Max output
size to maybe say a thousand now we have
this IOU threshold right here to
understand this concept of the IOU
threshold let's take back our example we
had here if we have this here
if you have this example
in order for this algorithm to know that
these two boxes are trying to predict
the same object and we want to actually
discard this one what will make use of
is this IOU
um threshold so remember we are seeing
the IOU already so if you have two boxes
like this this two boxes will compute
the IOU score that's essentially we'll
look for the intersection between these
two boxes which is this area and then
divide it by this total area occupied by
this two boxes so in this case it's all
this area right here so let's let's
let's have it back we have this here is
the intersection and then this year
totally
is the Union
so we take that intersection divided by
the union to obtain
um the IOU score now if that IOU score
is
greater than the IOU threshold like in
this case let's make let's specify an
area Treasure of 0.5 it is greater than
0.5 then we are going to discard this
box so we're going to discard this if
that iOS core happens to be greater than
0.5 now if it is less than 0.5 meaning
that if we have a box like this
um let's say we have a box like this
where this area this area here
is divided by all this area
is less than 0.5 then we are not going
to discard this box so we consider that
this box is trying to predict is is for
a different object and not this other
object so this IO this iot threshold
here permits also determine whether two
boxes are trying to predict
um the same object or not essentially so
that's it
and then here we have this call
threshold which is set to negative
Infinity
now the documentation he said that the
score threshold actually is alerted
float tensor representing the threshold
for deciding when to remove boxes based
on score so if you have a score
threshold of zero points for example one
then what you're saying is all boxes
which are which have a score of less
than 0.1 are going to be discarded
straight away mindless of or regardless
of whether
um
they overlap with a box of higher score
or not so that's it we get back here and
then now we could print out let's print
out
um our nomax suppression outputs
output let's run that
now one thing you'll notice here and
this output is the fact that we have a
single element now what the single
element actually means is
between all those four options we had
that is here we have this person we have
this person we have this person and this
person only this one year at this
position one is going to be left all the
rest will be discarded and to understand
why they're discarded you could look at
this course this is 0.96 this is 0.85
this is 0.96 this is 0.98
oh this is 0.985 not eight five so what
we're saying here is because this one
has the highest probability and because
it overlaps with the others like you see
here uh this one and this one will
overlap because actually represent the
same person then
um this others will be discarded
now in the case like this where we have
this exact same box with exact same
probability one is going to be left out
and the other one left so
um that's it we have our output now we
know that we only have a single box
instead of all these four boxes so we
have our nomax operation output The Next
Step will be to
um show visually what our predictions
look like
now yeah you'll note the fact that we
are going to write this in this image so
we we will draw the bounding boxes and
put the text on our image
only
for I in a normal expression output so
in this example we're going to do that
only once unlike the case where if we do
not have no Max operation we would have
had to do that four times so now we're
doing this only once because after
normal expiration we're left with only a
single box now take a look at what we
have here we have the X mean we have the
x max remember from the final boxes here
what we had here x Min
um what I mean like you see we have the
X Min we have
um the y mean sorry not the x max we
have the x max we have the Y Max and
then we have the color for the box and
that's it so that's it we now put the
text now we put in this text based on a
certain position so
um
the text itself is going to contain the
class from the final box you see we take
this last element remember from here we
have the class
and then uh once we obtain that class we
write that that's the text we're gonna
put to the text and then the position of
that text will be based on the X mean
what I mean values so you see we go we
go to x mean but for y mean we step 15
pixels
um downwards so that's it we Define the
font and the color and that's it so
we've put out this text
and then now we're ready to write this
out in our new image so we create this
new image and then we resize it
obviously the content of this image is
this here this image which on which we
have written the or we on which we've
drawn the rectangle or that's the
bounding boxes and the texts so let's
run this now completely and then you see
again we have one and we open this up
okay so we should be able to have our
output
and there we go you see we have a person
notice from here
um from here we had decided to go 15
Steps oops
let's take this off
we had decided to go 15 Steps let's go
downward
here we just have to go 15 Step that's
why you see the text comes slightly down
so if you if you if you don't have this
and then you do this
see it goes up and it's not very visible
so let's have that back you could
obviously change the color so let's say
and you could play around with all this
different parameters so that's it well
let's get back to the other color
because it's actually better let's say
we want to have one
so now we could run this for all the
different files and see what we get
well before we've been checking on that
let's suppose that we do not um have
this no Max operation output so let's
um leave out the normal separation
algorithm and see what our outputs will
look like let's have here uh for I in
range the length of the final boxes the
final boxes here had a length of four we
had four outputs
um let's take this off there we go
and then run this again and see what we
have
so we have outputs oops well we we
already had several different
predictions
um like okay let's let's take this one
for example you see here we have this
one
uh no let's take let's let's not have
that let's say we want to have here 40
let's get back to 40.
um 40.
okay so one thing you can notice here is
the fact that this you see we have these
two predictions for this person and uh
that's not what we want so you'll see
that the fact that we add this in a
normal Express operation here permits us
to remove some of the boxes so this
threshold is what you play around with
to ensure that you have
a single box for a single object
so here you can see that this model does
we already put it in the location of
this train and knowing that it is
actually a train we have this here
basically this is a person we have this
produce this person but unfortunately
doesn't get this other people here
um guess they're playing this person
this person well doesn't get this person
um does quite well here see this is the
dining table
um this person this person and this
person so that's great uh yeah we have
the TV monitor
um though it doesn't um gets a lot of
monitors okay so from here we also have
this bus unfortunately yeah we we it
predicts two buses
um a car also produce two cars maybe due
to this other curve in here then we have
this dining table and this person
we have this person and the dog we have
this person this person well Seal's a
dog here but that's not right
um person that doesn't see this other
person
um sees this two people here
um here since this person's though the
bottom box isn't um quite
well put out then we have the cut we
have this person
um we have this car
and then we have this person doesn't see
the dog
we have your scissors cows well this
this particular image was gotten from
the paper so just basically crop this
from the paper to test it out so this is
a person but doesn't see that this tool
a dog still actually locates them quite
well so that's it
um yeah this is a cat but doesn't see
this dog
um she's a person she's a cow she's the
person person Jesus two people sees this
person and this person though the bottom
boxes aren't quite well put out
unfortunately it sees cars
um not quite correct then yeah we have
motorbike in person but there should be
two motorbikes actually okay so that's
it we've just tested out our model we'll
see how
um it does or how it works with uh
images on which it has never actually
seen
hello everyone and welcome to this new
and exciting session in which we shall
dive into image generation so as you
could see right here this image was AI
generated
but back in 2014 2015 2016 images like
this
weren't yet to be generated using AI
with advances on AI like the version of
Auto encoders the Gans
and even more sophisticated guns like
the W Gans Pro against Sr against and
cycle against AI algorithms have been
trained to produce high quality images
and today we even get much better
results with the diffusion models
that said in this section we shall treat
the variational auto encoders and the DC
Gans
and so at the end of the section you
should be able to produce images like
this back in 2014 one of the best
performing image generation models was
this model you have right in front of
you that is the variational autoencoder
and the way this model worked was quite
simple
we had an encoded block which took in
some input image and then generated this
embeddance
and now this embeddings having encoded
information about the inputs could be
used by the decoder
to generate
output images nonetheless by 2014 iron
Goodfellow came up with this idea of the
gan
and the gun signifies generative
adversarial neural networks so here we
have two neural networks here the
generator
G and the discriminator where this G and
this d That's the discriminator are both
in some context where the generator
is learning how to produce images which
look like those from the real data set
or the training set
and on the other hand the discriminator
is learning
how to differentiate between real data
like this one and fake data produced by
the generator
if we consider this simple example here
you could see that we pass in some input
noise we get this output
and because this output doesn't look
like the real dealer the discriminator
consists this as fake
whereas now for this other example the
output from the generator looks like the
real ditter and so the discriminator
sees this or the discriminator is
tricked by the generator to think that
this is real data so after updating the
parameters of the generator and
discriminator such that we get to that
point where the discriminator no longer
knows the difference between what is
coming from the generator and what's
coming from the train set we now have
this generator block which is able to
take in random noise and generate
outputs which are similar to those from
our training set and although this
architecture was groundbreaking in 2014
2015. today we have more advanced uh and
better models like the Style again
hi there and welcome to this new session
in which we shall be treating the
variational encoder
and we shall see how it could be used in
image generation
in this first part we shall dive deep
into understanding the theory behind the
variational encoder and then the
subsequent sections we shall
practically Implement a working
variational autoencoder
that said we shall start with explaining
or understanding this Auto encoder and
would make use of this blog post by
Jeremy Jordan now to understand the auto
encoder
we can break this word into two parts
that's Auto
and
we have encode
so essentially we have a system which
self encodes itself
now supposing you have an image like
this one right here
when we pass this into some encoded
block let's let's have something like
this we have some encoded block and then
we could obtain this output Vector now
this output Vector is six dimensional so
yeah six different positions and each of
the position
represent a specific characteristic of
this image you could see your smile 0.99
skin tone 0.85 gender negative 0.73
beard 0.85 glasses 0.002 hair color 0.68
so all these six values here the six
values we have here
are
characterizing our image so they encode
information or information about this
image is encoded in this vector or this
Vector right here
and then on the other hand when we want
to retrieve this encoded information
what we could now do is we get a decoder
which takes this encoded information and
then reproduces this original image
and so that's globally how we produce
this kind of system which could be used
in image compression where we could take
this image encode it so that we have
just this Vector then we could pass this
Vector via some Network and then
um on the other side of the network we
decode this Vector such that we have the
original image
apart from compression and other field
where we could apply this kind of
autoencoder network is in image search
so let's suppose that we have this image
right here and we have
um this Vector now if we have another
image of this same person here so we
have another image of the same person uh
we call this image image B and here we
have
um image a which produces a vector which
we'll call VA then it means that in this
6D Vector space 6 because we have six
um different values here it could be 128
D or whatever Dimension we make it to B
so as we're saying we have this image B
which is the same image here the image
of this of this person but not
necessarily the same image maybe some
other image of the same person then
after encoding after passing through an
encoder you have our 6D Vector VB
but because it's
um a similar person or because it's the
same person would expect this values to
be similar and so VA will be close to VB
and if we have another person let's say
another person C
um this is here and if we generate that
person's VC that's this encoded Vector
then we would expect VA to be much
different from
um VC
and so this means that in an image
search scenario we'll just pass this
input we obtain this vector and then
we'll compare the two vectors to see
whether it belongs to the same person or
not
now it should also be noted that when
training an auto encoder model where we
have an image a and we have a
reconstructed image a prime then our M
year will be to minimize the difference
between a and a prime so we could
minimize a minus a prime
now it turns out that in image
generation to get better results instead
of dealing with discrete values like
what we had here let's get back to the
stop you see here we had the given value
let's take this off a given value for
smile for skin tone and so on and so
forth so as we're saying instead of
having a fixed value for each and every
one of these features what we'll do is
would make use of a probability
distribution
so here instead of having a value let's
say this is negative
0.6
we'll have a probability distribution
whose mean
is at negative 0.6 well this is this
looks more like negative 0.5 but um yeah
we're suppose now we're going from 0.6
to this probability distribution which
means a negative 0.6 with a given
variance now for those of you who don't
have a map background what this
essentially means is instead of picking
a value or picking the value 0 negative
0.6 what we'll do is we'll pick
some random value within this range so
instead of having negative 0.6 as we
said we're going to have a random value
in this range and
values closest to negative 0.6 have a
higher probability of being picked so
instead of having this we could now have
negative 0.3 or negative
um 0.55 or negative 0.75 and so on and
so forth so we have values which we can
pick in this range
now if we see this for example here
where we have 0 now turned to this
probability distribution we pick values
in this range negative one to one so
here the variance
are the range of values which
are in which we are allowed to pick a
value
is larger than this other one
but still values around this zero that's
the mean around this Zero have a higher
probability of being picked so here you
would have a higher chance of picking
0.1 instead of picking 0.9 to see that
clearly here let's say this is 0.1 at
this Mark and then this is 0.9
um around here you'll find that if you
link this up here this is 0.1 you see
that this has a higher score hence a
higher chance of being picked as
compared to this one which has much
lower chance of being picked so
in a nutshell instead of having this 0.5
we now have a mean value
which is 0.5
and
a variance which shows us
or better still gives us the range of
values for which we can
pick the specific value for a given
feature
and so as you could see this one here
has a smaller variance as compared to
this and as compared to this one
and from this point we'll Define this
mean
as Mu
and the variance uh which is some
distance from here
this distance as Sigma Square
this probabilistic approach to
generating a latent Vector which
previously was
um this Vector we had here scroll back
up previously it was this vector
is now what leads us to the variational
autoencoder
so you see that here we have our input
image
it gets into the encoder which produces
mu
and sigma square or let's just say Sigma
Sigma is a standard deviation Sigma
squares of variance so it produces mu
and sigma and then using mu and sigma
without decoder we're able to obtain our
reconstructed
output image
now note that in this case we would have
one two three four five six positions so
mu will be this six Z Vector Sigma will
be another 60 Vector where mu 1 this
first position here mu one and sigma one
represent the mean and the standard
deviation for this distribution
now it should be noted that the main
benefit of a variational autoencoder is
that they are capable of learning smooth
latent State representations of the
input data
now to better understand their
statements let's consider this output
generated by an auto encoder and this
other output generated by a variational
auto encoder
you'll notice that as we go from one
digit to another like let's say we're
going from six to eight here you see
here we have six well it looks very well
like six so let's let's take this one
which looks already very well like six
this is six but yeah it's really
confusing because we don't know exactly
what this is now this looks more like
eight but uh not really very clear and
then yeah we started getting eight and
eight and well this two doesn't look
very clear but when you look at the
output generated by the variational
encoder or the virtual Auto encoder as
we go from one digit to another
we can see here that we have an even
much smoother transition
and this is thanks to the fact that
instead of working with discrete values
at the level of our latent vectors
we're going for a probabilistic approach
with the variational autoencoder because
we're going in for this probabilistic
approach
the training of our variational
autoencoder is no longer evident and
this is simply because
during the training we need to compute
partial derivatives with respect to
Z
here
with respect to
mu and
partial derivative respect to mu and
with respect to Sigma
but because the Z we have here is drawn
from a normal distribution with mean mu
and standard deviation Sigma
we won't be able to compute this partial
derivative
and so the idea now will be to convert
this node that's here to one that is
deterministic you could see here we have
this key random node and then
deterministic notes so this one is
deterministic that's fine this one fine
um now well this is fine now the idea
will be to convert this into one which
is deterministic such that we could
compute this partial derivatives and
hence train the model
such that we could update the encoder
and the decoder parameters
and so now this
um idea of converting this node from one
which is random to one which is
deterministic is known as the
re-parameterization trick
so instead of having this where we have
well let's take all let's take this off
let's make it simple so we have this
where we have the mean mu
and the standard deviation
well we'll pick any value at random in
this range
we are instead going to Define this
um Epsilon which is drawn from a normal
distribution with mean zero so our mean
now will always be zero and then the
standard deviation will be one so we
have negative one one so this Epsilon
here as we've said is drawn from this
probably the distribution and then to
obtain Z unlike here where we
obtain Z randomly from
values surrounding the mean here would
do the mean plus the standard deviation
times a random value which lies between
or which surrounds
um zero
and so now we could compute this partial
derivative here
this with respect to Z
and hence string are variational
autoencoder model the next and final
point we'll look at in the section is
the rational autoencoder's loss
now from the auto encoder
all the variational autoencoder paper
the authors break up this loss into two
main parts the first part let's take
this off the first part is the
Reconstruction loss and this other path
acts as a regularizer
for the Reconstruction loss we try to
minimize the difference between X and X
or prime or
so we want that input and the
reconstructed input orders reconstructed
output should be similar
year is denoted as this we're trying to
minimize this and then for the
Reconstruction loss we're Computing the
Cal Divergence between
this distribution and this order
distribution now to understand what this
distributions actually signify
we can take a look at this figure so
here we have this cure
or the distribution cure
of Z
given X
which happens to be a learned
distribution meaning that
when we'll be training this encoder
model right here this is how I encoder
model we'll be turning this encoder
model
we shall in fact be getting this
distribution which as we've said already
is a learned distribution
nonetheless we do not want this learned
distribution to be very much different
from the distribution P of Z and so
that's why we are going to minimize
the distance between this distribution
and this all this learned distribution
and the true prior distribution P of Z
now it should be noted that the scale
Divergence here is a tool which permits
us measure the distance between two
distributions and so if we could
minimize this if we could minimize this
then we'll reduce the distance between
this distribution and the distribution P
of Z and getting back to the original
paper it should be noted that the
Reconstruction loss can be taken as the
mean square error while this year
will be our regular Riser and so this is
what we obtain after completing the Cal
Divergence between those two
distributions
hello everyone and welcome to this new
session in which we are going to be
building our own variational autoencoder
models from scratch previously we saw
how variational autoencoders could be
used in helping to generate new images
where we build out this encoder decoder
structure such that we could produce
outputs which are similar to the inputs
while being entirely new images
in this session what we'll be doing will
be to build our own variational Auto
encoders and generate our own images
the data will be used in training our
variational Auto encoder will be the
mnis data set which you could get from
tensorflow data sets so right here we
load this data set and then we
concatenate both the training and the
test data sets so uh generally we
usually have a data set made of say x
strain and Y train X test y test but
since here we are not going to be making
use of those outputs that's the wide
train and Y test we just get this tool
and then we concatenate both since we
not be having a test set so basically we
have that and then one other
modification we make is we are one of
the processes that we take is we divide
this values by 255 so we normalize our
data set so let's run this and then
once our data set has been downloaded
what we do now is we convert this data
set into the tensorflow data format so
we have our data set which is TF data
set
all right I did her TF theater did a set
from tensor slices so you see that we
take that and then we pass in our amnest
digits which we've already downloaded so
we run that and that should be fine
now we could check out the length of
this data set and you see you should
have 70 000 so we have seventy thousand
different data points which make up our
data set
from here we're going to define the
batch size so we would have a batch size
of 128.
that's it and then we'll go to the usual
steps of uh shuffling uh this set we
have already set we Shuffle we batch and
then we prefetch now if you're new to
this you could check out the previous
sections in this course anyways we have
uh this three as we've said and then now
we could run this
so that's it could say train
data set there we go you see that we
have this strain data set here and we we
could see its shape so it's all 28 by 28
by one images we have in our data set
and there are 70 000 of them so uh
that's fine
now get into the modeling we're going to
start with the encoder you can recall
that while we had uh seen so far was
oops what we had seen so far was this
model or this encoder model which takes
in an input image right here and then
outputs the mean and the variance so we
have the mean and the variance and then
this two
I've been
um
combined via the re-parameterization
technique where we have mu plus Sigma
times a random value drawn from a normal
distribution and then this Z is passed
into a decoder here
so we pass into a decoder and then we
get an output image such that the uh the
difference between this two is minimized
now that said let's get back to the code
and we design our encoder so our encoder
here is going to be a very simple conf
net we'll start by defining the latent
dimension
um there we go let's just put this right
here so latent Dimension will be two
we have that and then we get back here
for encoder we're gonna start as we said
with this encoder input so we have an
encoder input and then
this this has a ship which we're gonna
give to be 28 by 28 by one just as we
just the same as that of our images now
data set so that's the input we've seen
this already and then from here we'll
Define a conf 2d
a curve 2D which
um has
32 filters
of three by three Activation
relu so we're supposing that you already
have some background knowledge and
complex activation relu
uh number of strides equal to the
padding same so we just we're going to
build this very basic
um consonant now this takes in the
encoder inputs remember or recall we're
using the the Keras functional API right
here so we have encoder inputs we then
create another account layer which is
basically copy this and paste it out and
then what we would have here is an
increased
number of channels so we have 64 here
and from here we'll go ahead and flatten
our outputs now note that here we have X
so we should change this to X from here
we move on to flatten so we have flatten
and the sticks in X so now the output is
flattened
we are now going to Output both the mean
and the standard deviation which we are
going to use in sampling
but before that we'll pass this into
another dense layer so here we have this
dense layer could say 16 outputs uh
activation
activation relu and then we take in x
okay so we have that and now we're ready
to Let's just copy from here we're ready
to to get the mean and the standard
deviation
copy that
is it out here and this okay so here we
have the mean and we'll have the
standard deviation so we have dance uh
activation relu standard deviation and
then here since remember we have uh this
output to be the latent Dimension so
here we have instead of 16 we now we
have latent dimension
which we've already fixed right here to
be two
now one very important reason why we we
have those activations to be ready here
would be similar to the fact that the
the mean and the standard deviation are
all positive numbers so because uh we we
may output or we may get negative
numbers here we want to always make sure
that the values we get are positive now
the problem with the standard deviation
particularly is the fact that
it's usually a very small number between
0 and 1.
where the number is very far away from
one meaning that the number is very is
instead closer to zero so we have a
number very close to zero like this
but then the problem with working with
the relu is that having to find
derivatives
around this uh zero year
will lead to numerical instability
during training and so what we want to
do instead is to map this range of
values or this possible range of values
that the standard deviation can take to
a larger range now to carry out this
mapping we have to use a function
which is both continuous in this range
and monotonous that is either increasing
are decreasing now one great function
for this task will be the log function
as this log function will map values of
X in the range 0 to 1.
two values in the range
uh let's open it up here and the range
negative Infinity log or the limit as we
go to a zero of the log is negative
Infinity if you plot out a lock you
would have something like this
um let's have something like this so you
find that as you go towards zero log
take goes towards negative Infinity so
uh that's why we have negative Infinity
here and the log of 1
is 0. so we we go from this range to
this uh larger range hence we can have a
much more stable training process
and so what we'll do now is instead of
relying on this uh relative activation
to ensure that our standard deviation is
always positive what we'll do is we'll
instead compute the log
of the standard deviation Square which
happens to be the log of the variance
so we're going to take this off for both
those standard deviation and the mean
stick that off and then right here we
have
um log VAR that's a log of the standard
deviation Square uh log bar and then
we'll move on to the sampling process
where we're going to obtain Z remember Z
is equal mu which is the mean plus uh
the standard deviation times Epsilon
where Epsilon here is a random number
drawn from a normal distribution
we are now going to create the sampling
layer which takes in the mean and the
log of the variance and then outputs the
Z so here we have Z
equals sampling
there we go we're now taking as inputs
the mean and the log of the variance
and that's it so from now we're going to
create the sampling layer so let's go
ahead and create the sampling layer so
we have your sampling
sampling there we go and this is a layer
okay so we have that then we'll just we
just have this call method
which takes in uh inputs
let's let's just have our inputs and
then from those inputs what we'll have
is the mean
and the variance
so basically we have or we extract the
mean of the variance from those inputs
remember we have the mean and a log wall
let's let's see mean and the log bar
actually so we have that mean and log
VAR which we extract from the inputs and
then
if you remember what we have here to the
way we obtain Z is Mu plus Sigma times
this random number right here now let's
let's see how when given mu when we when
we get mu and we get the log of the
variance we are able to obtain this
Sigma because we already have mu but now
we need to get Sigma now note that Sigma
is a standard deviation and the standard
deviation or let's say let's just write
Sigma and Sigmar itself
is equal the square root of the variance
you see that it's a gold square of the
variance so it means that
um
and then we know that the variance
written like this can be really nice e
that's exponential to the power of log
of the variance
so generally we know that x equal e to
the log
of X you see that so here we have e to
the log of the variance and then we also
have the square root so let's have this
here now this is equal e to the log of
the variance let's just leave that at V
and all of this to the power of a how
we also know that e to the power of e to
the power of say x to the power of all
of this to the power of E is equal e to
the power of a x see that so here this
is uh going to be equal e to the power
of half times log V so it's going to be
half log variance
so um now we now that we have the log of
the variance to obtain the sigma that's
basically what we need to do
so let's
um get back
and then we have
uh the mean plus the sigma which is
uh exponential and then we have uh half
so 0.5
times the log of the variance
and then we need to multiply this here
the sigma by uh
um random value so we have TF the random
normal and then we specify a shape which
is simply the batch size and the latent
latent dimension
now that we have this we can now go
ahead and Define our encoder model call
this encoder model which is a tensorflow
model and we have encoder inputs for the
input there we go that's it here and
then for the outputs we have this list
made of Z the mean and the log variance
so we have mean and log far okay so
let's give it a name we'll call this
encoder now once we have this we could
uh get a summary of this so we have
encoder model summary
which we could visualize right here see
that
from here now we will move on to
defining our decoder
the decoder as we've seen already will
take in the Z
here
and then output the images
so we'll go ahead here and create the
inputs called this latent inputs and
then there we have a tensorflow input
and shape is going to be the same as
that of Z so right here we have latent
Zim and that's fine okay so now we have
this we're gonna take our Z let's get
back here
so now we have to up sample this Zer
which has a shape to now uh an image of
shape 28 by 28 by one
but generally what we've been doing is
we've been used to down sampling so uh
in down sampling we have an input we
have some confident layers
we stack them up and then when we get
towards the end we could flatten and
then we have some dense layers with a
specific output which matches the type
of output we want to get but in our case
we're now doing some sort of the
opposite of this so what we'll do is
we'll go through some dense layer here
go to some dense layer and then from
this dense layer would pass this into a
transpose convolution layer so we've
been used to the convolution layer but
yeah we'll use the conf 2D transpose
layer essentially what we have is this
come to the layer with its weights which
up samples inputs
now getting back to the code we have
this input which has shape batch size by
the latent Dimension let's say two and
then from here we want to make use of
account to the transpose layer which
takes inputs batch size
by some X by some y by some Z that's
similar to the conf layer so what we
will have to do is we're gonna uh
reshape this actually so we have to
reshape this search that we have
something like this now if we want to
have uh x y z sorry that X is say for
example 7 Y is seven and Z say 64. let's
take the example
then we have to ensure that what we're
getting after this has shape B by
um this seven by seven by sixty four
seven times seven times 64.
you see uh getting back here we have
this let's let's let's maybe redraw this
again so it's clear so what we're saying
is we have this input
and then what we intend to have is
something like uh batch size by seven by
seven by 64. now the reason why we're
picking seven is because the output is
uh 28 by 28 so one to be able to up
sample sorry that we could say seven by
seven of sampled to
14 by 14 and then the 14 by 14 of sample
to 28 by 28 so that's what we pick in
seven year now uh this uh year
you see it doesn't match with this
there's no way we could reshape two to
become this so what we'll do is I will
pass this through a dense layer which
has outputs batch by 7 times 7 times 64.
and now after reshaping we could obtain
this so let's get into the code and what
we'll have is uh dense layer dance oops
we have a dense layer
um seven
times 7 times 64. and then
we have the activation
activation relu and this simply takes in
the latent inputs so we have here lists
and inputs there we go now from from
here now we we do the reshaping so we
have x equal reshape and then we specify
the shape so we have seven by seven by
64. so that's it now we have that we
have X there we go we now start with our
conf to the transpose so you see we'll
reshape this into this now I could make
use of our account to the transpose come
to the
transpose
which takes in a number of filters it's
very similar to the conf layer so we
have a number of filters let's say 64
filters and then the the kennel size
three
the activation
relu so we're going to use the railway
activation number of strides
um two the padding is going to be the
same see so it's quite similar to the
common layer but the difference is that
now we have sampling instead of down
sampling so we have that then from here
we're gonna change this to 32 so for the
encoder what we did was we increased
this year this number of channels and
then here we reduce the number of
channels now in our final uh output
layer we're gonna have this decoder
output
which is going to have just one channel
so here we have an output which is 28 by
28 by one
where the values lie between 0 and 1.
so what we're gonna do now is we're
gonna have Channel numbers equal one
um
the activation instead of relu will be
sigmoid so here we have sigmoid
and then we're not going to use any
strides since we're not up sampling so
that's it now the reason why we're using
Sigma here is quite simple since one of
our values to be 4 between 0 and 1 we
want that each and every time we have an
input we have something like this so no
matter the input we have the sigmoid
will always put the the value or make
that input turn into a value which lies
between 0 and 1 and uh that's basically
what we want to do in this last layer
right here so that's why you see we're
making use of the sigmoid now once
that's done we create our decoder model
which is tensorflow model and then we
have uh latent inputs there we go we
have our decoder output
uh the name is decoder and then we could
uh get a summary of this model so that's
basically it
let's run that
and there we go see we have our decoder
model now for the training we're gonna
make use of the atom Optimizer with the
learning rate of
um 0.001 and we're going to train for
over 20 ebooks
now as we've seen already our last we
made of two parts that's a
reconstruction and the regularization
part now for the Reconstruction part uh
m is to minimize the difference between
this outputted image and the input image
so we'll go ahead and start with the
Reconstruction loss we have our custom
loss there we go it takes in white bread
it takes in y let's start with Y true
takes in y true y bread
and then the Reconstruction loss itself
is defined such that we have Recons
let's just say loss Recons instruction
is equal
TF Keras losses
uh binary cross entropy loss okay so uh
our outputs remember our outputs range
between zero and one so we could use the
binary cross entropy last year uh feel
free to test other different losses so
we have that and then we pass in y true
and Y print now once we make use of this
we are gonna now
uh sum all the values because we have in
let's say we have something like this
let's suppose that it was a five by five
outputs we are having so we would have
something like this so one two three
four five that's fine
five
there we go you see we have this five by
five here so with this binary cross
entropy we'll be able to get the the
difference for each and every position
here now we need to sum all this here so
what we would have is uh
uh let's take this off
we'll take this off
and we'll have the reduce sum so this
reduced sum now will sum all this
different
um difference or these different loss
values we get here so now we we sum for
each and every position obviously we
have 28 so it's 28 by 28 positions we
also need to specify the axis here so
the axis we're going to work with is one
and two one and two now to understand
why we're having this let's take a look
at the shape of the output is B by 28 by
28 by 1. but where we actually carrying
out this uh where we're actually
competing the loss is in this axis here
so uh we specify one two because this is
zero one two three so this is where one
of
um
computer loss so it's on this two axis
now said we have that and then we now
look for the mean so we could after
summing up we could look for the mean
let's average the values and that should
be it so that's it for our
um loss reconstruction The Next Step
let's take all this off the next step
will be this last regularization
getting back here you see we have this
sum see the sum of
um the the the variance plus the mid
square of the mean minus 1 minus the log
of the variance so let's get back here
and we have this negative half here if
you take this negative and multiply by
each and every one of this would have
um log VAR plus one minus the mean
Square minus the VAR
um before we continue remember again
that we could get Sigma J
as e to the log
of uh Sigma G
see that so also yeah yeah no let's
let's let's let's rewrite this better so
we have Sigma J equal e to the log
of Sigma J okay so that's it
um let's get back here we have uh loss
uh we'll still have this mean and sum so
we'll see uh average sum and then find
the average uh let's have that and then
we'll have
negative 0.5
times
the log VAR
let's get here we'll need a log far
oh let's say log mean and then let's
let's get exactly what we had here
remember in this um
encoder model we output the mean and the
log bar so let's have mean there we go
we have mean
and log VAR
okay so we have this set now we could
make use of it right here we have as
we've said already log VAR
plus one so we just have plus one minus
the mean Square so TF matte mean uh
around the square
of the mean and then minus
TF matte e to the power of log VAR see
that and now we return
the loss reconstruction
and the loss regularization so that's it
so this is our custom loss we run this
oh we get in this error
let's add this and run that again okay
so that's fine and we now set to start
with the training
but before going on we have to
um also specify the access for this sum
so right here we have this axis which is
equal one and we explain why we we
specify this axis to be one
now the shape of the log bar and the
mean is this batch by two and so the
shape of all the sum will still be this
and so if you're comparing this
or rather if you're Computing this here
you'll get this kind of output
and so since for the loss we need a
single value we need to sum all the
um values we get in this axis so that's
why you see we specify the axis to be
one we have this uh input which we
Define then we have the encoder model
which outputs z uh the mean and the
variance which we're not going to make
use of and then we have the decoder
which takes in Z and then produces this
output so here we have this uh vae model
which contains both the encoder and the
decoder now we're going to go ahead and
build our custom Training block we
suppose that you already have an idea of
how this works so we have that training
block which takes in our X batch and
then we're going to make use of
tensorflow's gradient tip so we will
have this with TF gradient
deep region tape there we go as a
recorder
we're gonna pass this batch into the
encoder so we have our encoder model
which takes in X batch and then what it
outputs is z the mean and the log
variance here we have this okay so we
have that set and then now once we get
this we we we get the Z from here and
passes into our decoder so we have our
decoder model which takes in Z and then
what it outputs is our y predicted see
that and now from here we could
obtain our loss by simply calling on our
custom loss method which we've defined
it takes in the Y true it takes in the
why pred why pred it takes in
um as we've defined here the mean
and it takes in the log variance now the
the this y true
why true happens to be the X batch
remember we're having
this year this encoder
takes in that
so we we have our input image here let's
let's take this off Android here it'll
be clearer so here we have this and we
have this so we have our encoder and we
have our decoder we have our input image
which is what we expect to have here so
our y true is what we pass as input here
which is this x batch so that's why you
see we specify y trials X batch then why
predates what a decoder produces so
we're going to compare the Y Fred and
then the Y true which is as we've said
already the x match
um that's fine we get back to the code
we have that set and then now
we
have our partial derivatives or partial
derivatives which we'll get by making
use of the recorder
so we have recorder gradient it takes in
the loss it takes in
the overall models trainable widths so
we have trainable weights okay so
talking about the overall model which we
yet to Define
we have it right here it takes in this
input 28 by 20 by 1 it takes the input
uh passed into the encoder model gets
the output from the encoder model and
then uh into the decoder model and then
from there we create our model which
takes in V AE input and this output
right here so from here let's get the
summary
and we see that we have exactly what we
expect so we have this model which takes
as we've said already this input the the
encoder output Z the mean and log bar
and then the decoder outputs this in
this image right here
so let's get back to our training as
we're saying where we we have this uh
partial derivatives from the loss and
the trainable weights
so that's it
we then go ahead with the gradient
descent step we apply the optimizer
so we have
optimizer.apply gradients there we go
which takes in our partial derivatives
and our trainable weights so there we go
we have the Z partial derivatives which
will just calculated right here
derivatives
and then the trainable weights trainable
weights there we go okay so that's it we
could from here just simply return the
loss now we're gonna run this
and uh let's we we haven't run this yet
okay so we have that already now we
could Define our neural learn method
so we have your neural learn which will
take in the number of epochs and then
from here
for the ebook
in range
epochs there we go we're gonna start by
printing out the training
starts for epoch number whatever input
we are at so we format that to take in
the ebook plus one since we're going to
start from zero or we could just take
this one from here and then there we go
now we have to add plus one here okay so
we have uh that and then now we're gonna
do for step
um X batch we're gonna enumerate
in enemy rate
um the train that is set which we've
defined already let's get back to the
top and uh we see we have our train that
is set so we're gonna go through the
screen data set
let's get back here
there we go so we we go through our
Trend data set we take a specific match
and then
we compute the loss so we have that
training block we should defined here
our training block has been defined here
so not only we compute the last but we
also apply the gradient descent step for
that specific batch so we're doing this
for each and every batch of our training
data set now what this takes in is uh X
batch simple as that now once we have
this the next thing we'll do is we'll
print out our loss so the training loss
um is
um there we go we have loss and then
once the training is complete
we could simply paint out
training complete
okay so we have that set now let's run
this and then we have neural learn let's
train for ebooks
um yeah we get in this error let's take
that off
that's fine let's run this again
so training is now complete and here's
what we get you see that all those drops
and then we can now get straight into
testing out our vae model now before
testing let's recall that our vae is
comprised of two units that's our
encoder and then the decoder right here
now we've trained this vae model end to
end to make sure that the inputs look
very similar to this outputs produced
now if we want to generate a new outputs
what we'll do is we're going to cut off
or we're gonna take off this region here
and focus only on the decoder now to
generate an image a random or to
generate a digit in our case at random
we'll just have to pass in a z in here
that's a random value of Z remember this
mu plus Sigma
Epsilon so we have to pass this value of
Z in here and then get a random output
now remember Z is two dimensional so Z
is this Vector made of two values and so
that said we will Define
the first values here which we'll call
grid X and we use the lean space method
to get values from a scale let's add a
cell above this so we would have a skill
or
which will take a value of one and then
we will have n equals to say 16
different values so here we go from
negative one to one
and then we'll have 16 values in between
uh repeat this for grade y
now so this is the first uh element and
this is the next element so here would
have different elements so that we could
generate different images
there we go let's run this and then
print out
uh grid X and uh grid y
now that we have this done the next
thing we'll do is we'll plot out our
different images which we shall generate
using our decoder so here we have this
figure we'll Define the fixed size
let's say five
anyway five by five and then
for I in greed X
and for J in greed y
we Define the different subplots subplot
um five by five by K plus one let's
define K right here so k equals zero
okay so that's it this is green not grad
we have greed that way and then now
we're ready to use uh to use this read X
values that's the values of I and J to
generate new images
okay so what we'll do now is this is
PLT the subplot so what we'll do now is
we'll have our inputs which is
tensorflow constant and then we have i j
so these two values and then from here
we have the output which is uh vae but
notice how we pick out uh layers to so
uh to better understand this you should
get back here what we defined our vae
model so here you see this is uh the vae
operational in Auto encoder which is
made of different layers so uh this is
layer 0 layer one and then Layer Two
um if you do v e dot layers
um let's say zero
see you have this input layer right here
now if you change this and say anyway
let's let's see for I in
uh range
to be
there we go we're gonna print this out
so we're gonna print our layers I
foreign that
and we see that we have this input layer
we have this functional model this other
functional model but you should note
that basically our encoder and our
decoder okay so that's set we're gonna
you make use of our vae layers here so
we have the layers two this is to say
that we're using the decoder actually so
our decoder is going to take in the
input see that it takes in the inputs
there we go and then we'll have
to select
um our first axis here so that's why we
have this and then we have to
um select this other axis right here so
such that our output now you see if we
if we do this
if we have zero here we do this see this
is not going to be transformed to 28 by
28 so basically that's why we do this
now once we have that we do the IM show
and then we have our output our map is
uh we
there we go
plot axis
um off
and then K plus equal one okay so we
basically increasing the value of one of
k sorry so that uh we could have this as
different subplots so let's run this now
and then see what we get
in this Arrow here so this is this is
actually because we're having many more
values as compared to what we defined in
here in this subplots so what we should
have here should be n and year should be
in that's set let's run this again and
see what we get
now as you could see we are able to
generate this digits making use of just
this Z Vector right here which is
composed of two numbers now one thing
you can notice here in this latent space
is that
as we go from values of negative one to
one in this two dimensional latent space
the outputs are created or
generated such that in each line as you
could see we have one digit which is
being
slowly morphed into another you see here
we go we start with a nine but as we uh
change values in this latent space you
see uh slowly we get to eight and then
you see eights and at this point you
start with a nine and then you slowly
get into fives and so on and so forth
you can look at this horizontally as
well as vertically you see that you get
to six and that and then you could just
look at this diagonal you see nine eight
uh three two six and then you get to
zeros so
um
for this first line all this first lines
you could look at this uh first lines as
going from nine to eight then you're
it's like from nine to five by passing
through three see and so on and so forth
so uh basically this is how we generate
images using variational Auto encoders
at this point one question you may ask
yourself is we are having this
um outputs which have been generated
from the making use of this Z Vector
right here
but how does the Z vector
this Z Vector your
of the different images vary with the
particular digits in those images so how
does a z Vector in say let's take this
for example in six vary with that of
zero uh with two uh and all other digits
to experiment with this we'll copy out
this code we had already
and then get back here
and now try to pass in the different
digits into our encoder and then plot
out the positions of
RZ vectors and then see whether there is
some
correlation with the Z Vector position
and the input we have here right your
other specific input digit
that said we're gonna not make use of
this so we have that and then here we're
gonna have a y train so uh this time
around we'll be needing the Y train
because we need to know exactly what
digit we're dealing with unlike here
where we just needed to have the input
images okay so that's it we have extreme
y train we're going to reload this and
then
we do the usual pre-processing from here
we run the cell and then we move
straight away to pass in those images in
our encoder
now similar to what we had here now
we're going to be making use of our vae
layers and then picking out the first uh
index so here we have uh uh output we
could call this or basically we have Z
then we have the mean and the variance
and then this is equal let's copy this
here
um there we go we have that then this is
now one see that and then from here we
pass in this x string
so that's it we pass in the X string and
then we could go ahead to start with the
plotting uh plot figure
specify the figure size
figure size equals 12 by 12. there we go
and then with those cutter plot now the
scatter plot will show us the different
positions of the values of Z that's the
Z points in our two dimensional space
let's take this off this different Z
points and then also we're gonna color
this such that
digits belonging to the same level have
the same color
there we go we're gonna plot this as our
X and then our y
so we have that and then I will specify
this y Train That's all levels so that's
it and then we can now go ahead to plot
out this color bar
and show
let's run that
and here's what we get as you could see
the levels here go from zero right up to
nine and then you could notice this
different clusters we have in here see
these different clusters you see that
this shows that
the encoder part of our variational
autoencoder has been trained such that
now it's able to
generate values of Z where
this point
is outputted such that two
inputs belong into the same digit will
be closer to each other as compared to
two inputs belonging to two different
digits so what we've been doing so far
is we've been training the variational
autoencoder model with our own custom
Training block you see right here we
made use of this gradient tape and
we carry out the gradient descent
manually as compared to when you just
have say model feet and then you pass in
your trained data set and basically uh
this takes care of doing the training
now the advantage of working with this
fit method is that it's quite simple to
use but uh compared to this custom
Training Loops it doesn't give you that
much freedom and that's why we're making
use of this
um gradient tape here to train our model
now with tensorflow it's possible to
actually get the best of both worlds now
this means that we can be able to train
or get us custom Training right here and
then still make use of the fit method
the way this is done is by overriding
the train step method
of our model which we shall Define
so that's set let's get right here and
Define this vae model then we go ahead
and Define this model as we would do
with a usual Keras model
but just as we had done right here
that's in this vae model we had built
here we need to take into consideration
or take us argument here the encoder
model and the decoder model so that's it
now once we have this two models
we have your encoder which is our
encoder model
and we do the same for the decoder
now once we're done with this decoder
let's type this out we have your decoder
uh as we're saying once we're done with
this decoder the next thing we want to
do is Define some loss so here we have
our loss
um it's actually a loss tracker now we
get to understand better why we're
calling this last tracker so here we
have the average or the mean of the
different losses which you should get
and then from here we'll go ahead to
this main section where we shall
override the train step method so uh
just like let's add this here just like
we used to working with methods like
model like the compile method like the
fit method here we have this train step
method which is called
each time we call on this fit method
right here
but since we are not gonna make use of
the default
um fit or the default train step method
would have to override this and write
out our own training block which is
basically this block we have here so
what we could do here is copy this out
so we could simply copy this out and
then paste it out here now let's just
copy all this there we go and oh that's
it we pay this out so here we have our
training block we'll call this
um train step so we override the string
step method which is
a Keras model method so here we have our
train step we're taking in our batch oh
there we go and then
it's going to be similar to what we've
had already in the training block so you
see here uh we have our z mean log VAR
uh which is cutting from the encoder
model and from here with past Z and then
we obtain y print we have our y true we
obtain our loss we've already defined
our custom loss method and that's it
then from here we're going to update our
loss metric so here we have
um loss tracker which we defined already
here we're gonna update its state so we
update our loss of state with the value
of this loss
so that's it now
we are going to return the result so we
have this dictionary we have loss and
then we have our loss
tracker dot result see that we have that
so uh there we go we have um updated our
loss we output a loss
but one important method we need to call
again is the metrics method so here we
have metrics uh you could Define several
metrics
but here we just have this loss and then
we return uh
loss tracker so we have lost tracker
returned now notice how this is actually
a list so you see there's a list because
we could have uh say different losses
which we could return and then we have
the property decorator which will place
right here so once we have this set you
see we do not need any more to make use
of this or to write this as as it was
written and so this means that we we are
not going to be writing out for example
training start for Epoch this uh the
training loss is this and all of that
now all we need to do is just call on
our model.fit method so right here let's
do
um let's run this first let's run this
right here
there we go and then we go ahead we're
getting an error
now uh from here we we Define our vae so
it's quite similar to to what we had
already senior see that now we have this
vae which is now this vae which have
created here so let's have that via e
equal v a e and then it takes in the
encoder model encode model and the
decoder model that's it so once we have
this now we could do just as we were
used to doing let's let's even say model
let's just say model and then here we
have model.compile as usual and then
here we're gonna pass in our Optimizer
so here we have Optimizer uh I guess
we'll Define this Optimizer already so
let's check here yeah we Define this
Optimizer so here we just have Optimizer
um equal
Optimizer which I've defined already and
then we do uh model dot fit see that so
that's all you just need to
um now make or call this feed method and
then we have our train data set which we
pass in the number of epochs uh we'll
Define this to be 20 and then the batch
size
um equal say 128 so that's it so here
um unlike before where we needed for
example to specify the optimizer in this
way and then actually uh get in-depth to
understand that this uh gradient descent
process needs for example the partial
derivatives and the trainable weights
now you'll see that unlike before where
if you were for example needing to make
use of some callbacks you would have to
write that
I include that in here with some custom
code but now all you need to do is just
have callbacks so we we both
well now to
write our own custom Training Loops
while still taking advantage of
everything that comes with the feed
method so right here you could have uh
some callbacks and that'll be it anyway
let's take this off and then let's get
back here well there's this slight Arrow
you see here we have this vae via
e.trainable weights and that now this
was in the case where we had defined our
vae this way we had this model and then
get into our custom Training Loop right
here let's get down here we had to
actually uh oh we the way we got the
trainable weights was from our vae model
which we had defined now given that we
we have this vae model right here the
way we access the strainable weights is
by using self so we have self.trainable
weights and then here we have solve that
trainable weights
and this is simply possible because we
are inheriting from a Keras model which
already has this different
attributes which have been defined now
that said let's run this that should be
fine train are complete you could see
that
um
we're getting our usual outputs when we
making use of the feed method
and then we could go ahead and start
with the testing so we run the cells and
then in here we have some modifications
to make so right here or previously we
had this layers and uh predict and we
took in the inputs and we got some
output now here we have our model
model that predicts you see that but
this model is a whole vae model so since
we want to make use of our decoder we're
going to say model.decoder model there
we go model dot decoder actually the
decoder because here you define this
decoder attribute so we have model dot
decoder there we go dot predict and that
should be fine okay so let's run this
and then see what we get
there we go you see we have exact uh
same kind of outputs as when we were
having our own custom Training Loop
right here
and that's it for the section hope you
enjoyed it see you in the next section
hi there and welcome to this new session
in which we are going to delve deep into
generative adversarial neural networks
in the previous session we have seen how
we made use of the variational
autoencoders to generate this kind of
outputs which are in fact mnist digits
from just an input noise so what we had
was this kind of encoder decoder
structure where we had some input images
here like this one for example some
inputs and then we train the model such
that the outputs look like this inputs
and then once training is done we could
take off this encoder and then just pass
in a noise signal in here and then
generate new
outputs like what we have here which
look like those from the original data
set
and in the section we'll be seeing how
to build a new set of or a new category
of generative models known as the Gans
and we'll use them to generate images
like this one which we have here you
should note that all those images are
images of people who do not actually
exist
but before we dive into practice and see
how to build models which can build this
kind of realistic looking images
we shall start by understanding how this
generative adversarial neural networks
that's against work now this Gans were
first introduced in this paper by
goodfully all where the Gan architecture
was first proposed
and to understand how the games work
let's make use of this figure from Louis
Bouchard's post now let's suppose we
have the bank who produces real money
you see here we have this real 100 bill
and then on this other end we have the
thief who produces fake money you see
here
um this hundred dollar bill has this man
with a mustache which isn't the case of
the real dollar bill
and because differences like this and
say for example this compared to this a
very clear
or can be easily seen this police
officer is able to detect that this
money is fake
but when this police officer detects
that the the banknote is fake
um he or she says that uh it's fake
because we have a mustache for example
because we have this uh what fake
written on it because this hundred has a
fake uh around eight and stuff like that
so it tells the the forger or the teeth
what needs to be ameliorated in order to
make sure that the next time this thief
presents this fake money to the police
officer the officer thinks it is maybe
this real money
and so if we suppose that real money
takes a value of one and fake money
takes a value of zero let's change the
color fake money takes a value of zero
then let's say in the first years of
production of this fake dollar bills the
police officer correctly says okay this
is a zero and this is uh one that's oh
it's very evident at the beginning but
then with time this thief gains
experience
and now produces fake money which looks
just like the real money
and this now pushes the police officer
not to be able to distinguish between
the real and the fake any longer
now although we did not advocate for
this kind of malpractices it turns out
that this is the way the Gans actually
work
and in our case we'll replace this
generator or we replace this thief by a
generator model which is a neural
network so this is going to be a neural
network and we replace
this police officer by a discriminator
which also is a neural network
specifically a binary classifier which
takes in some inputs and says whether it
is real or not
whereas our generator here takes in some
random inputs and then learns to Output
this banknotes such that the
discriminator thinks that it is real
now we shall head on to the Gan lab
which is a project by minsukang at all
and we'll consider some very simple
example so here we suppose our data
distribution is this year see that and
then notice how we have a generator
we have a discriminator and then the
generator takes in some random noise and
then outputs this sample and then the
discriminator takes in the sample and
says whether it is real or it's fake
now apart from this fake samples it also
takes in the real samples and then also
says whether it's real or is fake now
now the weights of the generator and the
discriminator are being updated such
that
after some time this samples which are
going to be produced will look very much
like this right here
so
um let's go ahead and click on run and
we'll see what we get
you see how we start with the training
let's take all this off see we start
with the training for now the fix let's
let's pause and start over uh let's
restart that okay you see initially
we're getting this kind of outputs you
see this output you could you could look
at this here so this is this is a kind
of sample generated and this is the that
of our real
litter right here
and one thing we notice is that at times
as time goes on you have your both the
green and the purples which are
considered to be real and then there's
all uh only the purpose considered to be
fake so this discriminator now starts
making errors when it comes to seeing
whether given sample is real or not
whereas on the other hand the generator
is now producing samples which look much
like the real samples
and it's because of this competition
between the generator and the
discriminator that he actually called
the Gans generative
adversarial this adversary uh comes from
this competition between the generator
and the discriminator
and it now leads to the generator
producing samples which look very much
like the real samples
one other point you should notice that
as we carrying out this training overall
we have two main parts we have this
block right here oh let's take this
block we have this block
which consists of
wearing when the discriminator takes in
this real and then outputs some value
the the output from this is used to
update the parameters of the
discriminator and then when the
discriminator takes in this
um
and then when the discriminator takes in
this fake samples this
output here is used now to update the
generator so we have this block
wherein we update our discriminator and
we have other block wearing we update
our generator
so with that now we could pause this and
you could change the data distribution
and so again in comparison to the with a
VA East where we had this encoder and
then the decoder well if we have a
distribution like this one so we have
some uh some inputs we we want to have
or we want to be able to Output
or get outputs which will look similar
to this input distribution
and then after training this
encoder decoder we now
uh uh break this up
and then make use of only this decoder
to now generate output which are similar
hours distribution is similar to that of
uh
this real inputs right here
again another important point to note is
the fact that after training uh after a
certain number of ebooks at some point
where when the reels and the fix look
very similar the discriminator now
becomes somehow confused as if you
notice here you find some green patches
you see you have some green patches
purple patches here we have some green
patches and purple patches so it's no
longer able to distinguish between the
wheels and the fix
and so instead of uh as before or as the
beginning where I was able to say this
is a one and this was a zero now it says
this as a 0.5 and this has a 0.5 it
becomes confused
and so in fact the aim of again training
process will be to
ensure that the generator wins the fight
it should be noted that most of very
cool applications of Gans are in the
domain of
image generation and so we'll look at
some of these applications in this
article by Jonathan Hoy games can be
used in creating anime characters you
see here we have this anime characters
which have been generated
automatically using Gans and so this
means that
um similar to what we had here we're
gonna have a real data set which
produces images similar to what we have
right here let's get back here similar
to what we have right here and then
we're gonna have a generator which we'll
learn over time to generate images which
will look like uh the real images and
that's how we get to have images like
this one
now from here we also have
um post-guided person image generation
here for example you'll notice that we
have this input image and then you want
to have this same person but with a
different pose then we could specif we
could pass in this post and then get
this output right here so you see that
we have this input that's this image
with this different pose and then this
has been generated another application
is in Cross domain translations so you
see here we have this input where we
have this to say three zebras and then
we are able to transform this input
image automatically into this other
domain where we instead have horses and
so
um this image or this input or this
output rather has been generated from
this input and this could be done in the
reverse direction as you would see here
we see you could go get from zebra to
horse as we had here and then from horse
to zebra then we have another example
this is a star gun which permits Us
carry out translations or
Transformations where we modify specific
high level features of an image so right
here you see we have this input and then
we add for example blonde hair you say
changes uh the gender modified so that
this this male becomes a female
um aged she's aged and talking about
aged you could build an application
which tells you or which shows you what
you would look like after say 2050 or
years then here we have pale skin
another or some other modifications we
could have here is he angry
um happy fearful and that so that's it
you you see making use of this um star
again you could carry out this kinds of
Transformations on an input image the
next we have this pixel DT gan
which creates clothing images and styles
from an input image so you see we have
the source image and we have this
different images which have been
generated from this source we have other
examples right here as you could see
and then
we have super resolution now for super
resolution
Gans have been used
to increase the resolution of an input
image
while making this higher resolution
images more realistic so you see this
image for example this by cubic this one
right here which has been
a garden using the bike cubic method and
then we have this other image which is
uh using a resnet and then now you'll
notice that there's some difference
with the kind of outputs we get using
again notice how this image here looks
more realistic or looks much more like
the original as compared to what this
other two non-gan methods produce to
even get a much clearer difference
notice this uh part here where we have
this water pouring you'll notice how
this looks much more realistic as
compared to using a classical neural
network like the resnet then from here
we move on to the next application which
is uh that of generating faces but this
time around very high definition faces
so here you see you have 1024 by 1024
images generated you see this uh images
of people who do not actually exist
which haven't gotten using a pro game
that's a progressive gain now
um
we move to the next we have Style again
which even comes with much better
resolution and with some styling so uh
from here we go on to high resolution
image synthesis where we could get we
see this semantic map and then from here
we generate this output we have right
here
then
um the next gogans
which as we've seen already takes these
kinds of
um semantic maps and dense uh produces
this output you see this is the the
ground truth this is the exact output
and this is what the Gan produces so
that see from here we're able to produce
this from this we're able to produce
this now this kind of Technology could
be applied in video compression in a
sense that
doing a video call where we have this
input so we're suppose now we have this
this is a sender and then this is a
receiver we separated by this uh dotted
lines right here so we have this input
um right here and then we carry out key
Point extraction where we get this key
points as you could see here and then
this is what's been transmitted via the
network so instead of transmitting this
input we transmit this key points and
then making use of some keyframe which
has been passed initially we combine
these key points with the keyframe
um to produce now this output right here
which looks like this original input
which we wanted to pass and so now at
the receiving end we are able to get
this here at a much lower bandwidth
since we're taking in only the key
points and not this whole input image
then we also have applications in text
to image where we could pass in a text
like this flower has long 10 yellow
petals and a lot of yellow anthers in
the center
and this generates this kind of output
now talking about those kinds of
applications we could check out
crayon.com which is in fact uh Dal e
Mini model where we'll be able to create
much more realistic outputs so let's
click on this
and while this is loading we could check
out on the other applications
um the next application text image we've
seen this already phase synthesis
you see right here we get
um with a single input image we create
faces in different viewing angles so for
example you can use this to transform
images that will be easier for face
recognition so if we suppose that we get
in this kind of input
um let's say we get this kind of inputs
we could generate or we could convert
this for example into this one year such
that it will be easier for a face
recognition model to do its job
now from here we go to the next one
image in painting okay so right here we
have this inputs let's increase this
um take this off so as we're saying we
have let's let's pick this one for
example we have this input right here
but we have this patch which has been
taken off and now making use of again we
are able to generate an output which
will be like this input without the
patch so just like the Gan takes this
patch off
and as you could see the Gan does its
job quite well
let's reduce this
there we go
before we move on let's get back to this
output created our icrion.com
and you can see that this dial e-mini
model produces even much more realistic
um images
then we move on to the Discord games
where we could create outputs which
match the style of a given input so
supposing you want to go out on a little
trip you want to see take this back and
you wanted to get some ideas of the kind
of shoe you could put on then you could
make a call on the Disco again and
you'll get this kind of output based on
your input so this is oh
a model which is similar to the cycle
again
which we had already seen right here and
where we were able to leave from one
domain to another
one other fun project will be to
generate emojis from input images see
here we have this input image for
example and we have this Emoji which is
generated from the input
then another very interesting
application will be in the blurring so
right here we suppose that we have this
input image which is uh clearly blurred
and then we want to deploy this image
you see that we're able to produce this
kind of images making use of Gans
and you can see from those images here
that again do this job quite well
another application is in photo editing
and so now you do not need to be some
expert in photo editing to carry out
some of this photo edits
all you need now is some gain and you're
good to go apart from image generation
against 2 can be used in music
generation though in this course we
shall focus on image generation then the
medical domain Gans could be used in
anomaly detection and that's it for the
section in the next section we are going
to look at how this ganza actually
trained in practice and the type of loss
functions we use when training this
again
hi there and welcome to the session in
this session we're going to look at the
again loss function and also how guns
have been trained
then finally we'll look at common Gan
training problems
so for a brief summary of what we've
seen already we'll consider that we have
this two distributions right here this
distribution of this one uh this black
dotted lines represents
the real data that's similar to what we
had here so similar to uh this real data
right here and then this other
distribution in green represents the
fake dealer which is going to be
generated by our generator so
um getting back here we have this oh you
see this here which is our discriminator
so right here we have the discriminator
D then we have
as we've said already the real and the
fake distributions
now once we start training we have this
discriminator which sees that most most
of the real data is uh getting the score
of one or it classifies with the
probability of one that this data is
real and then as we approach this
generated data as we get samples from uh
generated distribution we find that the
discriminator now outputs a zero
now as we keep on training the
generation
gets better and then the generated
samples now look a bit more like the
real data you see they come they get
closer this uh distance here becomes
smaller compared to what we had before
so uh We've trained and we've gotten to
this point where now this discriminator
still sees the real data to be one but
now confuses are
sometimes classifies this fake data tool
to be one so you see there around here
see this sample so we consider to be
once or classified as one though we'll
still have some samples classified as
zero and then once we get to convergence
we have this uh half here so we have
this
um classifier now which is unable to
differentiate between the real and the
generated of fake ditter because the
distributions look very much alike and
so that's it for the recap of the
previous session now we're gonna dive
into the gain loss function so right
here we have this um training algorithm
which we could see here expand this we
have this training algorithm and if you
notice we have this two um loss
functions here one for the discriminator
and the other for the generator but this
could be combined into one equation
right here let's take this year and now
we have our two player Mini Max game
with this value function V now when we
talk about this min max game right here
it makes allusion to what goes on
between the generator and the
discriminator so our two players in this
case are our generator and a
discriminator now one thing you could
also do with this gen lab is you could
put out your own uh distribution so
let's
um say for example this distribution we
apply and we start a train and the the
generator now together with the
discriminator start to play this game
where at the end or at conversions we
expect the generator to produce outputs
which are similar to that of the
discriminator now coming back to these
equations you'll notice that we have me
and G and Max and D so to understand
this notation
you can consider that we are minimizing
this expression right here
by updating the parameters of G and then
we maximizing this expression by
updating the parameters of D which is
our discriminator where G is our
generator
and then if we try to separate this tool
that's to to get for the to to start
with amazing for example for the
generator you'd find that given that in
this first expression you see this is
this expression right here let's have
that so in this expression there is
actually no G so we could make use of
only this when we're trying to minimize
this whole expression with respect to
parameters of G so that's why if you if
you check in the
um algorithm given to us right here you
find that for uh loss for G you have
only that second expression now for the
D let's get back here for the D this is
in the both sides or this both this
expression and this other expression so
that's why we have the combination of
the two in this uh algorithm right here
now to better explain or better
understand this in depth let's consider
this year so we've extracted for the D
and for the G you should also note that
let's get back here while we talk about
updating the discriminator or updating
the generator is basically uh within
descent step remember if we have for
example tether
um and all right if we have let's take
this off if we have tether at a
particular step let's say step I uh to
get better at I I plus one step then we
would have Theta add as a previous step
or let's say I minus one
um let's take this off so we want to get
Theta I it's equal to the I minus 1
minus the learning rate
times the partial derivative of the loss
with respect to our getter
I minus one so this is basically what we
have in here and this expression here
where we have this
um reversed
triangle that's oh this right here is
actually this section of our gradient
descent
and so this means that we're finding the
partial derivative of our loss this is
the loss with respect to the parameters
tether
and then we have the same for the
generator now let's get back here where
we're gonna oh
understand in depth what all these
different Expressions actually mean
right here we have this real sample and
this fixed sample so this two here we
have real and thick and then uh with
this real sample we pass it into the
discriminator which uh we hope or which
we will train to see that this is a one
and then for the the fake sample because
this is a person with who doesn't exist
whereas this person actually exists and
we train again uh which we'll see later
on in those cars uh to produce this type
of outputs so um let's get back here we
have our discriminator then we we from
here let's take let's instead shift this
um let's move this this way so let's
take this right here yeah okay so we
have that
and then here we have this right here
now this is our fake sample and then we
have our generator let's change the
color for the generator so our generator
produces this and then we have some
random noise which we send in here
because we just we just want to be able
to produce this from some random noise
so we we have this random noise right
here which produces this our G which
produces that
um fake sample and then we have our
discriminator who is able to classify or
say whether an input is fake or not
okay so getting back here let's take
this off getting back here
when we want to train our discriminator
we're gonna have an input X right here
see this input X now this input X is
this real sample right here so those are
X
um I which is which is this here and
this is our discriminator which takes in
this input then once it's discriminator
takes this input is expected to Output a
one and if you get back here let's get
back here you find you're told update
the discriminator by ascending its
stochastic gradient and then you update
the generator by descending the
stochastic region now generally when
we're trying to ascend or ascending on
descending actually is different like
while we've seen already where we had
Theta equal Teter minus learning rate
partial derivative of the loss with
respect to debtor is gradient descent
which is actually what we're doing for
the generator but when we talk about
gradient Ascent it's actually this
instead we have a Plus instead of a
minus see that so
um if we have
for uh let's plot our loss function
here with respect to debtor for our
gradient descent that's a classical
gradient descent what we want to do is
to minimize this loss but for our
greatest Ascent we want to instead
maximize this loss
and then getting back here before we
move on we'll consider this plot of the
log function so here if we have X and we
have log of x then we have a plot which
looks like this oops let's have this
there we go and this is one
so when x equals one the log is zero and
then well as X takes smaller values
approaching zero the log goes towards
negative Infinity so as we as X goes
towards zero obviously from the right in
this direction going in this direction
then
the log of x goes towards negative
Infinity so that's it now let's get back
here uh for the discriminator as we've
seen we're having a gradient Ascent so
we're trying to maximize this remember
from our Mini Max
um loss function we we tend to maximize
our discriminator so when we when did
the discriminator takes in a real sample
um it tries it gives us an output of one
and
with an output of 1 the log of 1 as
we'll see here is going to give us zero
so the log of one is zero so this will
give us a zero now you should note that
all the outputs of our discriminator
range between 0 and 1. so our
discriminator is uh our usual classifier
so it's going to Output values between
zero and one and so getting a value of
zero is the highest
um you could get as an output after
passing through the log so let me
re-explain we we have this discriminator
which output value between 0 and 1. oh
let's plot it out let's reply it again
here so the discriminator outputs values
between 0 and 1. see that so this is
what is the simulator outputs and so
when when you when you have the log of
this values between 0 and 1 then the
maximum value for the log
will be a zero you see that the maximum
value for all these values which is
around 1 will be a zero so when you have
a zero it means you've maximized this
and that falls in line with what you
expect because we want to maximize this
uh
expression we have right here okay so we
get back here for the reels we want to
Output a one and the log of 1 will give
us the maximum possible value which is
in this case is zero now uh for this
year we have a z remember this x is this
real image here this year is our random
noise which we have seen already here so
when this random noise passes through
our generator we output a fake sample
see that the generator takes in a random
noise and then this generator let's have
this here the generator outputs this
fake sample and once it outputs this are
fake sample we now take this fixed
sample and pass it into our
discriminator and we expect our
discriminator to produce instead of a
one this time around
a zero see that
and in our case uh the log the log of 1
minus a zero is a log of one and the log
of one is zero that's the highest
possible value we could get when we're
dealing with logs in the range zero to
one so we maximizing this you see that
now it's less understood we could move
on to the generator for the generator we
want to instead minimize this expression
so since we're trying to minimize the
expression
we would expect the output from this to
be negative Infinity as the lowest
possible value but uh let's get let's
put in these values and see how we'll
obtain this negative Infinity now we
have Z which is our random noise
when the random noise passes through G
it outputs this fake sample again and
now this time around we expect d
to consider this fixed sample this time
around to be like a real sample so what
we're saying here is
at one instance we want our
discriminator to see this as real
another instance one a discriminator to
see this as fake
and depending on the instance we're
gonna get or we're gonna update uh
parameters of the corresponding Network
so in the case where we want to see this
as a fake we want to update the
parameters of the discriminator
such that it sees this as fake and then
the case where one is to be seen as a
rule by the discriminator one will be
updating the parameters of the generator
so in fact
um what's going to be happening here is
let's change this color uh when training
the discriminator we're gonna freeze the
generator so we're not going to update
these parameters we're going to update
the parameters of the discriminator now
when training when training let's get
back when training our generator we're
gonna freeze this year
oops when training the generator we're
gonna freeze this and then update this
parameters Solitaire is able to fold the
discriminator to think that this is a
real sample and when it thinks it's a
real sample it's gonna output a one
Now log of 1 minus 1 is log of 0 and log
of 0 is negative Infinity
see that and this is the minimum
possible value so we're minimizing this
expression so getting back here we have
for a number of training iterations
that's basically for the number of
ebooks uh we're gonna do K steps we're
gonna update the discriminator we are
key steps see four key steps do this we
take we sample a mini batch of noise we
get the noise uh mini batch of real
samples then from here we obtain uh we
get the generator outputs and then we
obtain the output loss which we use to
update the discriminators parameters and
then uh for this key steps
I think in here let's see we use k
equals one the number of steps to apply
say use k equal one so you could modify
this although in practice k equals one
is fine so
um getting back here after going through
key steps for this we're gonna update
now a generator so sample mini batch of
M noise again so just like this then we
obtain this output from the generator
this time I only expected to fold the
discriminator so we're going to update
the generator by descending this
stochastic gradient such that it folds
the discriminator and that's it for the
section in the next section we're gonna
get into some practice and see how to
get this kind of results we had here so
these are the real samples and then uh
what we'll obtain will be something like
this see we're able to generate this
um fake outputs of this people we do not
actually exist and they look pretty
realistic then one point we have to note
before we move on is that the type of
neural network used in this original
again paper is a classic artificial
neural network and this will kind of
outputs they got but in the practice
we're going to be making use of the DC
gain so instead of the the simple game
make use of the DC gain the DC actually
stands for deep convolutional
um and that's it do you see deep
convolutional so this again means deep
convolutional generative adversarial
neural networks okay so here we're gonna
be looking at this um neural networks
which are convolution based and so with
that see you in the next section
hi guys and welcome to the session in
which we are gonna write the code
for generating images like this in
tensorflow from the previous session we
had looked at the gain loss function and
now we'll see how to adapt
this loss such that we could instead use
the binary cross entropy loss
and then from there we'll go ahead to
look at different methods to make a gan
training much more stable you can see
from here that the scan training is in a
very stable process since
um we have two adversaries where one is
trying to maximize the loss and the
other is trying to minimize the loss so
by Nature
Gans are more difficult to train as
compared to other classical neural
networks then after looking at how or
looking at different methods to make
this gun training process more stable
will go ahead to train our gun from our
previous session we had the
discriminator loss and the generator
loss now we want to introduce the binary
cross entropy loss you'll notice that it
looks quite similar to what we have here
now let's start first with the
discriminator for the discriminator it
takes in this real image and then we
expect it to Output
uh one see that we expect to have a
Wonder now uh for the binary cross if if
we have to compare this with binary
cross entropy then this y Chapel this or
wire is going to be equal
r d of x i which is practically what we
have here so this is our Y shapu and
then uh yeah y this y i Chapel is going
to be this year now when uh since we
want our y to be equal one it means that
1 minus y will be zero so we will not
consider this but because the only this
part right here now if we consider only
this part we are left with this
expression since Y is equal one and then
when y equals zero the case where we
have this sorry this y sharp equals zero
then we'll have log of zero which is log
of negative Infinity minus that with
this minus which we didn't have here is
now in this year because we're dealing
with the binary cross entropy the
negative of the negative Infinity gives
us positive Infinity so it means that uh
for y Chapel equals zero we instead have
positive Infinity so here since we want
to have y sharp o to be equal one then
um our aim will be to minimize the
binary cross entropy loss since the
values we could get will range between 0
and positive Infinity unlike here where
the values were ranging from negative
Infinity to zero so here we was
maximization problem we had uh gradient
Ascent but yeah we're trying to minimize
this instead so uh we minimize this
because we want to obtain a zero since
it's when our output is zero that uh or
is when our y sharp o is equal one that
but we get this output of zero so that
said we have it for this first part for
the next part when we're dealing with oh
our theater uh fake data which has been
generated by our generator we expect Z
to be equal zero and since our Y in this
case is equals zero since we have y to
be equal to zero then this term is taken
off and we left with only this term now
for this term we would have one minus
the expected value of D which is zero
that's one log one minus y Chapel where
y sharp o is what the model predicts so
um in the case where we have this y
Shuffle to be equal or zero as expected
then we would have log of zero and that
will give us zero so it would have a
zero here now in another case on in the
other case where our model in such
predicts one year the model answer
predicts one then we'll have log of one
minus one which is going to be zero log
of zero is negative Infinity this
negative here turns out to positive
infinity and so now we have positive
infinity and since our aim is to obtain
this y sharp port to be zero it means
that it will minimize this uh expression
here such that
it takes the value of zero over the with
the aim of having a value of zero
and again unlike this original
expression where we went from negative
Infinity to zero now we're going from
zero to positive Infinity
and so this means that when working with
um the discriminator and making use of
the binary cross entropy would go
through a simple gradient descent where
we will minimizing the loss
from here we will move on to the
generator for the generator well we
expect D to produce a one right here so
we expect them to have one year
and this means that this expression is
taken off since we have 1 minus 1 which
is zero so here we left only with this
now we're left with our bit is one so
it's just log log of Y Shuffle which is
what the model will predict or what this
D the discriminator would predict and so
we have negative anyway let's just say
negative let's take up mid the one on n
and the sum so we have this expression
right here and then in the case where
the model actually predicts a one so the
model suspect is pretty good one and
actually predicts a one in that case
would have a zero in the case where the
model predicts a zero when when you're
supposed to predict the one in that case
we'll have log of zero that's negative
infinity negative negative Infinity is
positive infinity and again here our aim
is to obtain uh this zero right here so
we'll again be minimizing
our BCE loss
now given that we'll be implementing the
model or the architecture in this paper
that this again paper
we should note some of these guidelines
here we told replace any pulling layers
with strided convolutions so instead of
using pulling we use traded convolutions
and fractional strided convolutions for
the generator
um the next use batch Norm in both the
generator and the discriminator then
remove fully connected hidden layers for
deeper uh architectures basically here
we're using the convolutional layers
instead of the fully connected hidden
layers uh use real low activations in
generator for all layers except for the
output which uses the Tang activation
then use leaky relu activation in the
discriminator for all layers but before
we move on to look at some of these
details we should note that there is
this GitHub repo here by one of the
other authors of the paper that's
um there we go let's get up here by
Sumit shintala and what he proposes here
is this list of tips and tricks used to
make guns work now as we said already
it's it's not that evident to make Gantt
work so take taking advantage of the
experience from one of the authors of
the original DCR of the this again paper
not the original gun paper will be very
interesting for us since we will not uh
get to make the same mistakes which
maybe he had made uh before discovering
all those different tricks now that said
we have here the very first one you
should note that this list is no longer
maintained I'm not sure how relevant it
is in 2020 so this is this has been for
a while uh this year six years anyways
we have uh normalized the first one
normalizer input so normalize the images
between negative one and one then use
stench as the last layer of the
generator I guess this was already in
the paper the next tip will be to modify
the loss function now it should be noted
that we've already explained this but
maybe the transition from this previous
loss function to this other loss
function wasn't made very clear now
let's get back to that call for our loss
function we have that
um we had a log of 1 minus D of G of Z
that's for the generator remember so we
had only this year only this expression
in the original again paper they
expected the discriminator to produce a
zero although previously we had
mentioned that we expected discriminator
to produce a one right from the
beginning we've been speaking of this
but in the original paper what they
actually wanted was the discriminator to
produce a zero
for the generator before we go on to
look at how to compute this BCE loss we
are going to take into consideration
this modification on this original loss
right here and this modification comes
in because of the following problem when
the train just starts it's difficult for
this discriminator to Output A1 unlike
here where it's easier for it to Output
a zero when it sees fake data because
remember let's get back to this and uh
let's restart here
let's restart this
and let's pick another distribution oh
let's let's pick this one which is
slightly more complicated so when you
just start with the training the the the
generated outputs you see here the
generator outputs do not look very much
like the real deal see this here it's
very different from this and so because
of this great difference at the start of
the training it's difficult for us to
make the generator fool the
discriminator to Output a one right here
and also because of the fact that
classifying whether an input is real or
not is easier than generating new inputs
the generator here will experience
Vanishing ingredients and so instead of
as we've seen already trying to minimize
this we can instead maximize the sum of
log d g of Z so instead of log 1 minus
DG of Z we're going to have log d g of Z
the reason why is preferable for us to
use use this expression where we
maximizing this year instead of
minimizing this other expression is
simply because when we make use of this
expression we are being more lenient on
the generator at the beginning of the
training especially so
when we're minimizing the log of 1 minus
d g of Z we had levels or if we were to
make use of the binary cross entropy
loss we would have levels which are
equal zero and so if our level equals
zero obviously this expression is left
out and we left only with this part now
we're left with y equals zero and then
we have log of 1 minus y just similar to
what we have here but then the fact that
at the very beginning we are expecting
our discriminator to Output y equals
zero when it sees fake data from the
generator is a problem because is a very
easy task for the general for the
discriminator especially because right
here or at the very beginning this year
is obviously not going to look like the
real theater and so the discriminator
will find it very easy in
um predicting that this is fake Gator
and because of this is the generator's
weights wouldn't be updated any further
to ensure that we could produce even a
more realistic looking fake images and
so what we we do is we flip the levels
and flipping the levels matches with
this expression that is Let's uh take
this off we are having now y
equal 1. so instead of y equals zero we
now uh have y equal one so we expect in
the discriminator to Output one when it
sees fake data from the generator now uh
doing this we have y equal one so
obviously this is left out you see that
this now matches with maximizing this
expression and so when y equals one now
we are telling the discriminator to
Output a one year when it sees fake data
and now this will permit the generator
to be able to update its weights and so
make the training much more stable as
compared to when we're dealing with uh
or working with labels y i which are
equal zero you should also note that
when we're talking about levels here
we're talking about this y eyes and when
we're talking about what the model
predicts we're talking about this y hats
or these y shaples our next tip is one
which we've discussed already so we told
in the Gan paper is the last function to
optimize G is the minimization of log 1
minus d but in practice Fox practically
use max of log D this uh what we are
seeing already where we had the
minimization of 1 minus log d g of Z so
we had
um log sorry log of 1 minus d g of Z
right here so we minimize this
expression and then now instead of this
we maximizing
um the log of d g of Z
and the reason why we prefer to work
this way as we've said already is
because if you are expecting the
discriminator to take in some fake data
from here at the beginning and say that
it is fake then this is going to be a
very easy task especially at the
beginning since the fake uh data year is
gonna look very much different from the
real data and so because we our aim here
is to make this discriminator output is
zero is going to be difficult for the
generator to update its parameters such
that the discriminator can start uh
getting fooled and so instead of this as
we've said already we flip the levels
and uh instead aim for the discriminator
to Output once
for the next tip we'll set uh they say
don't sample from a uniform distribution
so for the noise or here for a generator
noise we're going to sample from a
gaussian distribution or normal
distribution okay so from there we're
encouraged to use batch normalization
avoid sparse gradients and unlike in the
paper if we get back to this again paper
and we check let's get to this we check
here we we told use we leaky railroad
activation in the discriminator for all
layers and then use activation the
generator for all layers but what this
here is uh the Leaky Railway is good in
both the G and the g that's about the
generator and the discriminator then one
point you should notice the fact that
the stability of the Gan game software
is if you have space sparse gradients
now what do they mean by this uh if you
have a relu activation if you have some
input all negative inputs
are sent to zero and all positives
remain the same then for the Leaky relu
we have all negatives
which will take up some value depending
on what we picked the value to be if the
value is 0.2 for example then an input
of negative 1 will give us an output of
negative 0.2
uh an input of negative 2 will give us
for example uh negative 0.4 and input of
say whatever value stamps uh stems uh
negative 0.2 to get the output now that
said the this the positive section
Remains the Same but now when we talk
about those parts gradients here it
comes due to the fact that if we have a
relus in our Network then we tend to
have many zeros and the zeros are or
will cause this sparsity in the gradient
and so because we do not want to have
this and because we want to train them
against in a more stable manner then
we'll make use of the Leaky relu
then for down sampling we told to use
average pulling or conf 2D and strides
then for up sampling you speak the
shuffle kind of transpose convolutional
transpose 2D with strides okay then from
here we told to use
soft and noisy levels so what does this
mean this means that if we have a
discriminator and let's say we're
training our discriminator
where we have an input from a generator
uh we we train our we update the
parameters of the of the generator uh
where we pass in
our fake data from this output of the
generator into our discriminator and the
discriminator has to compare the the the
output from the model let's let's put
output from the model on this color
let's say the Apple from the model 0.4
for example so what we'll be comparing
will be this
correct level with the model's
prediction you see that now uh what this
here is apply levels moving so instead
of
taking one we could take a random value
around one so instead of this we could
take for example say
1.2 or 0.8 or 0.9 or whatever uh value
just around one so instead of having
hard levels just like some strict levels
either we have zero or we have one or
um take values around so around let's
change the color we'll take values
around zero
and then values around one you see that
so we use smooth leveling instead of
some hard uh leveling
then we also told to make the level make
the levels the noisy make the
levels noisy
for the discriminator that's
occasionally flip the levels when
training the discriminator okay so
that's fine now next uh use this again
when you can it works so if you do if
you can use this again and the model
table use hybrid model
like for example the vae and again now
here we have been told that if we were
to generate images we should not use the
original Gans that we should not use
um the simple
neural networks that's a fully connected
neural networks we should going for
convolutional neural networks okay
the next is to use stability tricks from
reinforcement learning now we we're yet
to treat your enforcement learning so
we're going to skip out this now from
here using Adam Optimizer optim Adam
rules so the after Adam Optimizer rules
and then track failures early so if you
want to be able to train your Gans
without maybe a regretting at the end
that you you haven't or you you can get
the kind of results we expected you
should try to ensure that you make sure
your Gan isn't doing any one of this
right here so if you're training and you
and your loss the loss of the
discriminator goes to zero then it's
failure mode because your discriminator
is proving to be too good at doing its
job and then if the Norms of the
gradients are over 100 things are screen
up when things are working the loss has
low variance and goes down over time
versus having huge variants and spiking
so what the senior is if we have this
the loss for the discriminator remember
we have discriminate on the generator uh
what we expect to have is something like
this it should go down slowly over time
instead of having this kind of oh
High variance and spiking now if the
loss of the generator steadily decreases
then it's full in the D that's the
discriminator with garbage and so this
means that we do not expect the
generator to be so good that during
training it's lost just drops
um steadily and so as we've said already
you should track all this failures early
on now the next we have don't balance
loss via statistics unless you have a
good reason to now uh they say they've
tried it's hard and they've tried it all
um let's take this off so what you're
saying is
won't try to balance the training of the
generator and the discriminator based on
some loss value so
if you are to try this you should have a
principal approach to it rather than
just intuition
now if you have levels use them now
talking about levels this means that if
you have
say we have this our discriminator and
then we have our real dealer
and then you have maybe some data set of
fake data then you could train your
discriminator like the usual classifier
in supervised learning then the next
point is to add noise to the inputs and
then Decay over time from here we have
this tips where they're actually not
sure so or we may just keep them
actually uh this is for conditional
gains we'll not take this into
consideration use drop outs and G in
both train and test phase so provide
noise in the form of drop out as this
generally leads to better results much
thanks to the authors Smith Emily Martin
and Michelle then apart from the
vanishing gradient uh problem another
very common problem would be that of
mode collapse where the generator
produces output or produces the same
outputs even after training for several
ebooks and so now we're gonna start with
building all this again while taking
into consideration the tips and tricks
which we've just seen
hi there and welcome to the session in
which we shall practically train our
gain to produce images like this one
here we'll start with the Imports and
then we'll move on to prepare our data
the data set we shall be using will be
select a data set which signifies select
faces attributes data set now this is
over 200 000 images of celebrities with
40 binary attribute annotations let's uh
open up some of this here you could have
some of those images open this file up
and there we go you see we have this
faces right here and so what we'll be
doing will be to train our discriminator
alongside with our generator such that
our generator can generate image of
faces which can be able or which can be
realistic enough to be able to fool the
discriminator to think that they're
actually real faces this notebook is
provided by Jessica Lee on Kegel and and
can be downloaded so let's uh go
straight away to download this set and
then start with uh this again modeling
in order to download a data set from
Kegel we'll be needing the chicago.json
file right here now this kind of just a
file can be gotten from kaggle by
getting to your account and then
creating a new API token so once you
have that you'll get right here and then
click on copy API command which when you
paste are here you see you have Kegel
data set download and you have the the
the username of the person who uploaded
this data set to kaggle platform and
then you have the data set name right
here but before carrying out this data
set download we'll start by installing
Kegel we'll make this directory we'll
copy this character Json into this
directory then we can now go ahead and
download this set from this command API
command which we downloaded or we should
copy it rather and then we can and I'll
unzip this into some data set folder or
directory which we specify so that said
let's simply run the cell and everything
should move on well let's take this off
as you can see the data set has been
downloaded and now we're extracting the
files into this data set folder right
here now that we have this successfully
extracted into our data set folder as we
could see we specify the batch size the
image shape and the learning rate now
from here let's run the cell
and then we move on to create our
tensorflow data data set so here we have
let's call this data set and then we
specify this path now to get this path
you could click open right here and then
you see if you click open this it's
going to take a while since we have 200
000 of different images here so let's
just let that and then we copy this path
there's a path that you specify in your
now once you specify that you have or
you have a leveling mode which is known
um we have the image size which was
specified already we have
um the batch size
um anyway let's let's we could
um have here
batch size but it doesn't matter as
we'll see shortly anyway we have that
and then from here we run the cell you
see you could have data set we're
getting an error tensorflow not defined
let's run this
oops
um that's fine uh next this we run this
already and then we run this now this
should be fine let's check out our data
set should use that so as you can see we
have 202 599 files belonging to one
class and our data set has been batched
so we have a batch data set you could
see the shape right here we have 64 by
64 by 3 images now uh the default is
um 256 by 256 so if we if we do not
specify this let's see what we get let's
take this off
um take that off and run this again and
check out on the image size
you see here when you don't specify
anything you have 256 by 256. okay let's
get back
and run this again then we move in to we
process our data so right here what
we're going to do is we're going to make
sure this data lies between negative one
and one and so that's why we're having
here the image divided by 127.5 minus
one and so this means that any value we
get between 0 and 255 let's say for
example we have the value 255 we'll take
divided by
127.5 which is 2 then -1 which gives us
1. so that's how we we process this
images and then after pre-processing
we're gonna unbatch because we need to
reshuffle or or rather because we need
to drop the remainder so we unbatch and
then we use the batching of our
tensorflow data I then from here we
carry out some prefetching for a more
efficient way of loading the data now
from here you can visualize a single
element and all that is set there we go
we have 4D in our train data set let's
take a single element we could print out
its shape
the shape and there we go now we have
this shape which is 128 by 64 by 64 by 3
as expected and we could go ahead and
visualize
um some elements here so let's visualize
four elements
um we could increase this definitely so
we should visualize four elements of
this for now now here we have the
subplot
um plot in show and we could
take off the axis so let's run that and
then see what we get
so here we have this
um four different images let's reduce
this a little
now uh one thing we could do to is
modify this here this um value of our
array now the reason why we want to
modify this is because this value
reaches between negative one and one
whereas this Platinum show takes in
values of range zero to one so we're
gonna modify this so that we move from
negative one one to the range 0 1. and
to do that we need to take whatever
value we have in this range add one to
eat and then divide by two so let's take
this off
then again back here we just have plus
one then divided by two
there we go let's run that again
and there we go you see you have now the
images are much clearer and you you do
not get the
messages which we're getting previously
now we'll go ahead with the modeling and
we're gonna use this same architecture
presented in the DC again paper so right
here we have this 100 dimensional latent
vector and then
this is projected and reshaped into this
4x4 by 1024 tensor and then from here we
apply the up sampling that's actually
the conf 2D transpose to then get this
other Vector right here notice how we're
getting from four by four to eight by
eight and then from here again repeat
the same process 16 by 16 32 by 32 and
then finally 64 by 64. also notice that
while the size of the outputs keep
increasing from eight six from 8 to 16
32 64. the depth is reducing so we'll go
from 1024 to 512 to 256 to 128 and
finally we have three so we get back to
the code and we specify our latent
Dimension which is equal 100 let's rerun
this cell right here there we go and
then that should be fine and then we go
ahead and build our generator so here we
have our generator or which we'll build
with a sequential model we have TF Keras
sequential and then
we start to pass in our different
um layers so here we have our input
layer input which uh has a shape of the
latent dime or Latin Dimension so here
we have latent dimension
there we go and that's fine so that's
our first layer and then the next is our
dance layer so this is our projection so
we project this such that the output is
um having four times four
times the latent dim
number of output units so just as we had
seen in the paper now once we have this
we move to the next layer which is going
to be the reshape layer so we go ahead
and reshape such that because at this
point we haven't uh letting them is 100
so we're having 16 times 100 that's 16
100 outputs now we reshape this so that
it is a
three-dimensional tensor so here we have
four by four by latent
latent dim and that's it
there we go so this is our next layer we
shape from the reshape we go ahead to do
the con 2D or the up sampling will come
to the transpose uh as is the paper we
have curve to the transpose and then we
have 512
number of filters represent the number
of output channels then the kernel size
Canal size equal four
now if we get back to the paper here
let's get back to the paper you'll see
that the candle size
isn't necessarily exactly equal four but
one very important rule to follow when
picking out the kernel sizes that the
Canal size has to be divisible by the
number of strides so when we pick Canal
size equal four we could have the
strides to be equal to
and the reason why we generally want
that the candle size is divisible by the
number of strides is simply because of
the
or quality of outputs will get generated
by the generator when this isn't the
case so
um always ensure that we have the
channel size divisible by number of
strides now from here on we go on to
apply batch normalization as suggested
um in the paper and also in the
tips and tricks of GitHub repo so here
we have by genome and then from uh after
the bachelor we have our leaky relu now
for the Leaky relu we have it takes in
value of 0.2 so here we have 0.2 and
that's it for this first part so we have
this first block here which you could
see in the paper this very first conf
layer now uh once we have this here
it could be repeated again so we just
um copy this and then paste it out but
modifying this depth so here we have 256
and then again oops here get back
um and then here we place this out and
then here finally we have a hundred
and 28. okay so we have that uh for now
we're not going to apply any drop out
you could always feel free to apply that
and see
um the kind of results you will get so
here we have this and then uh now we
have that we we already said that we
have the let's get to the paper we have
the first the second and the third kind
of layer now this final account layer is
to get an output which is like an image
so we have 64 by 64 by 3. and so let's
get back here
um uh we will have no leaky relu or what
also or whatever like that just copy
this out and
this is out here okay so we have that
and now we just come to the transpose we
have uh activation which is a tench so
in after the strides here we'll specify
the activation activation and this
activation is uh
um tense Activation so just have attach
and that's it padding
um equals Sim
we also got the bases out here so we
have here we have pattern same and right
here we have pattern same okay so that's
it uh that should be it for the
generator I guess with uh respected what
we had in the tip and tricks and also
um right here let's see we're told use
radioactivation and Generator for all
layers except for the output which uses
the tench we'll call this model the
generator so we have our generator model
and then let's run that and the next
thing we want to do is summarize this so
let's get a summary
we check this out here
and you see are we getting this here
instead of three so let's go ahead and
modify this right here uh this should be
three let's run that again
[Music]
and get the summary
okay so this is what we have
then now we could move ahead to our
discriminator so instead of generator
right here we have this creminator and
the input we're gonna have here is gonna
be 64 by 64 by three so it's actually in
shape so m shape
um zero index m shape
there we go by three and then
instead of the conf 2D uh transpose
layers we'll be using the conf 2D layer
so here we have conf 2D and then the the
depth increases instead you're instead
of decreasing as we had with the
generator so here we go from 64. so it's
Tower 64 and then we move on to 128 and
so on and so forth for now let's take
this off since we're doing with the conf
2D and then again we have the kernel
side which is divisible by the number of
strides we have the Leaky relu as we've
seen already in the tips and tricks
um take this off here that will make use
of the batch knobs too so let's let's
place this out and then we have batch
batch normalization
we have the batch normalization
there we go
um here is called 2D but we increase the
depth so we have 128. now that we have
this depth increase we just simply copy
this out and paste it over the next
layers so over the next blocks because
we consider this to be a block and
there's a block and this a block now we
move on to 256
[Music]
still and that's it now the for the
final or for the last count layer let's
just place this out here let's take this
off
oh we have this last count layer right
here
we'll give it a depth of one and then
given that our discriminator called out
our discriminator is uh a usual
classifier which takes in the 64 by 64
by 3 input and then outputs a single
value whether one or a zero or a value
between zero and one actually so the
output is a single value here so at this
point we should be thinking of using
some dense layer and then I'll
specifying that it's output is going to
have only one unit
okay so let's take this off and then now
from here we could
um flatten so we flatten
um what we get is output from the conf
2D layer and then after flattening we
could uh have our dense layer
one see here we have just one output and
then uh the activation
activation is sigmoid so that's it
recall with a sigmoid
with the sigmoid we have values or or
inputs from negative Infinity to
positive Infinity which have been mapped
in the range 0 or 0 to 1 actually
and that's exactly what we need right
here so we have that
um that's fine let's take this off now
before we move on it should be noted
that unlike the sigma in which Maps
values between oh zero and one the tens
function marks values between negative
one and zero so this is from 0 to 1 and
then the tangent Maps values between
negative one and one
and that's why we use in the final layer
for the for the discriminate for the
generator and now for the discriminator
we're using the sigmoid okay so we have
that understood now we have here are
this creamy nature okay so we have that
let's run the cell and then finally
we're gonna have a summary
discriminator summary
let's run this and then see what we get
there we go we have our summary
um everything looks fine and now we
could go ahead and start with our
training and just like we had done
previously we're gonna override the
training step so here we have
a vae model which we had built
previously where we override at this
train step right here and with this
we're able to make use of methods like
the model.fit so here instead of the vae
we have again
let's get back we have again model
this game model is made of a
discriminator discriminator and a
generator so let's replace the encoder
and decoder by the discriminator on the
generator respectively
then here we have uh discriminator
discriminator and uh generator self
generator
and solve
this creaminator
we can modify the compound method Let's
uh modify this compile method the
compile method actually will take in the
optimizer for the discriminator the
optimizer for the generator and then the
loss function so we have uh the
optimizer let's say as the optimizer G
Optimizer and then the loss function
so that's our compiler method and then
we also go ahead and Define our
discriminator loss metric and uh
generate a loss metric uh we've taken
all this three and then we've put this
out here okay so that's it now let's
have our the loss metric and r g loss
metric and then from here we move on now
to the training step for the training
let's recall that we have a
discriminator we have a generator and
then this generator takes in fake data
your Dixon or vector fake this uh this
noise here and then generates fake data
so takes noise or G takes noise generous
fake ditter and then this fake data is
then passed on to the discriminator
which says whether it's a one or zero or
gives the value between zero and one
okay uh we also have a real data right
here which is also going to pass into
our discriminator and it's also going to
give a value between 0 and 1. now it
should be noted that we'll start with
training the discriminator and when
you're training the discriminator we're
gonna freeze the generator that's we do
not update these parameters so we're
gonna just update the weights of the
discriminator
just like we had seen previously
so the first thing we want to do here is
to get our noise the noise is TF random
normal
so we have normal and then we specify
since we have a normal distribution we
want to specify its shape now the shape
of this here would be
um the shape will be our latent dim now
let's let's have our little team which
we've defined already so here we have
latent Dimension now given that will be
working in batches we need to add the
batch Dimension so here we have batch
size by latent dim now to obtain the
batch size all we need to do here by
size is equal
TF dot shape of RX batch
X batch and then
we get the zeroed value now from here we
have the batch size we have the noise
and then we're ready to fit this into a
generator and then obtain the fake
dealer then also make use of the real
dealer which is basically this year
because this is a real data remember our
data set it's made of 200 000 different
images or faces of celebrities and what
we've done is we will broken this up
into batches of 128 so for every uh
batch we're gonna take this x batch here
which is basically the real dealer and
then we're also gonna use make use of
this noise generate a fake data and then
train our discriminator
and so with that we have our fake ditter
or let's say fake images fake images
equal self
generator which takes in the noise
or let's just say some random noise
here we have random noise so random
noise Vector actually okay so we have
this now we have our fake images that we
have this year now the next and we also
have the real so we can now dive into
training the discriminator
now you should be noted that the
discriminator's loss function will take
in
the output from here the output from the
real dealer and compare it with one and
then taking the output from those fakes
and compare it with zero so we'll take
the output from the real let's call this
r
and compare with one and then we take
the output from the fix let's call it f
and then compare it with zero so getting
back into the code right here let's
change this let's call this real
images and here we have real images
real images there we go so here we want
to have the predicted
output
or better still let's say real
predictions real predictions so here our
real predictions here now the whole
positions are gotten from taking in are
discriminator
discriminator and then uh this commit
actually takes in uh real images so
we're presenting what's going on
um right here so we have this rail which
gets into our discriminator and then we
output the real predictions which would
then compare with the value one so
that's it we can now go ahead and
compute the loss so we'll have
discriminator loss for real is equal
our loss function which we're going to
pass in and then this last function
takes in the real predictions
and
uh once so here we will have
both the real partitions and the real
levels are the real levels as we've said
already are the ones so it's basically
this one year since we we're having
batches of uh images we we have several
ones of size by size so here we have
real
um we there we go we have real
um levels see TF ones and then we
specify its size all better still is
shape so here we have the the shape
which is batch size by one see that by
size by one and the reason why we have
batches by one is simply because we have
an output which takes in just one single
value while this output will uh for all
the real level will be equal one and we
have the batch size okay so we have that
now the next thing want to have here are
the fake levels now this fake levels is
going to be this zeros right here so we
have oh sorry we have zeros and then we
have by size and one okay so that's it
now we we have our real levels and we
have our fake levels and we will take
the real levels we'll take the real
predictions that is we take we we get
what the model thinks about a particular
input that's all the classification and
then compare it with the real levels the
real levels is ones because we expect
that the model should take in a real
input and then know that it is a real
input and that and that means that it
should output a one when it takes in
real data and if it outputs a value
different from one then the loss is
going to be greater than zero whereas if
it's exactly equal one the loss is going
to be zero and M years minimum is loss
now we have that and the next thing we
want to do is repeat this but this time
around for the fake predictions
so here we have fake predictions now the
the first step is we have a real data
getting into the discriminator and the
other we have fake data get into the
discriminator so here we have fake
predictions and this time around it
doesn't just take the real images but it
takes uh the generated images so we have
self-generator and it takes in uh uh
noise actually so we should take in a
random noise which is this uh one right
here so it takes some random noise
and then it outputs fake images
but since we've defined this already
here we could just make use of it here
so here we have fake
images and there we go so yeah yeah we
have the discriminator which takes a
fake image and then uh gives us a fake
prediction and we're going to compare
this fixed position with zero so we
expect that the the fake predictions
should be zero if not the the loss isn't
going to be equal to zero so here
instead of real levels we have
fake levels so we're comparing zero with
what the model is gonna predict
or the output of the discriminator uh
yeah we have discriminate a fake we have
here fake uh that's it I think that's
okay we have the same loss function
actually is a binary cross entropy loss
and once we have this now we could have
we could Define d loss to be equal the
last real
plus d loss fake
since that's basically a combination of
this two losses right here
now before you we move on if you could
recall in the tips and tricks we saw the
levels moving now here we have our
levels our real and our fake levels
let's separate this and now what we're
gonna do is instead of taking a one
we'll take values around one so we take
we add plus uh
0.25 times some random value between
negative one and one so basically what
we're saying here is we want to take uh
this one and then add it plus a value in
the range of negative 0.25 and 2 5 on on
0.25 so this means that now instead of
having uh the level to be fixed at one
we would have the level to be between uh
because 1 minus 0.25 is 0.75 so it will
be between 0.75 and 1.25 instead of just
one so that's how what our level will be
now and then for the zeros since we we
wouldn't want to have negative values
we'll take the zero plus some random
value between 0 and 0.25 so instead of
zero we have some random value between
zero and
0.25 okay so that said what we'll do now
is we'll get right here we have TF
random uniform and then we specify the
mean vowel which is negative one and
then the max vowel which is one now
specifying this means we're going from
negative one to one and then multiply by
0.25 means we're going from negative
0.25 to 0.25 so that's basically it
and then also we specify its shape so we
have
um the batch size by one there we go now
we're just going to copy this out and
then paste this right here so we don't
want to have negative numbers so we
start from zero instead so here we have
zero to one but uh by default the values
are already from zero to one so we could
take this off okay so that's it uh
everything looks fine
I think everything is done for our
discriminator
um now we have in this let's take this
off uh we have our loss and that's it
okay so that is uh basically it we now
move on to our partial derivatives here
we take in our D loss
and then we are going to update
um the discriminator so here we have
this Cree discrete nator dot trainable
weights then uh for the optimizer
is an Optimizer which we have specified
already right here so here we have
instead of this Optimizer we have our D
Optimizer which we're going to specify
so we have the optimizer uh takes in the
partial derivatives and Alternate
weights again here we are training only
the discriminator so we have discrete me
neither that's it so here we go we have
our model again the discriminator the
trainable weights and we repeat the same
process here now oh this is self okay so
that's it uh this should be fine now and
then next step we do is we're gonna do
this same but for the generator
so what we'll do now is we're gonna
again sample some noise
random noise here we'll copy this code
out and then paste it out after this
okay there we go so we have this random
noise right here
random noise
and then from this random noise
we have our fake images
um so
generator and it takes in the random
noise
okay now we're gonna have the same again
so we're gonna
make use of the gradient tape as we've
done already with the discriminator so
is that out here and then here we have
we'll be working inside with a generator
um this is discriminator discriminate
let's go back discriminator okay so as
we've said this is let's let's just
commend this let's try it out uh
generator
and then right here
um we have the this screen discreminator
okay so there's a discriminator and now
photo generator so as we're saying we
have those fake images we have our
random noise and we make use of this
random noise to generate the fake image
but this time around we want to fold a
discriminator so
um instead of expecting our fake levels
to be zeros as we had here this time
around our fake levels will be once and
we'll obviously not have anything to do
with the real data so let's take this
off and then get back here uh now we
have the fake levels uh which which is
equal one and it happens that they have
actually been flipped so let's let's uh
get down here
and then pieces out here so here we have
ripped
flipped fake levels which actually once
instead of zeros remember we've seen
this already so we have that and we're
not gonna do any level smoothing right
here so we have that and the next thing
we want to do is start with uh
recording of the gradients
now yeah let's take this off
we have our fake predictions we have uh
here we go discriminator takes in the
fake images and that's it now here we
have the flipped flipped
fake levels and then we have our thick
predictions
fake predictions I guess if we we should
have had we should have made an error
here this is actually fake
fake predictions or comparative fake
predictions with the fake levels and
then here we're comparing the fake
predictions with the flipped fake levels
so that's it
um that should be fine here we have G so
this is our G loss
self generator
that's it Raider and then here we have
updating our generator so we're gonna
making we we are not updating the
parameters of the discriminator here now
here we have G Optimizer that's it okay
so um if that's okay we have now
to update the different states so we
have the last metric
we update the state and we pass in the D
loss and then we repeat the same for the
G loss that's the generator loss so here
we have G and then here we have G
then for our loss we have G loss
uh G loss metric results
metric that's it and then here we have
uh D loss
self
D loss metric
and then results
okay
let's now run the cell and normally
everything should work fine now we move
on
to define the number of epos so we're
gonna work for 20 ebooks and then let's
get back here
we Define again
which is this again we've just defined
and then it takes in the discriminator
and the generator which we defined
already
uh from here
we go ahead and compile the model so we
have again compile and then we specify
the optimizer the optimizer Optimizer
which is uh the item optimizer
optimizers
and then Adam
now this item Optimizer will be or with
a learning rate learning rate
which was specified already at the
beginning learning rate equal
2 times 10 to the negative 4 which is
specified at the beginning so we have
your learning rate and then beta 1 beta
1 equals 0.5
now we will put the same for the
generator let's get back here copy that
and then paste it out here so this is
for our generator now now you notice
that there's no there's no major
difference actually there's no
difference we just use the same
Optimizer now we have that the next
thing we want to do is pass in our loss
function so we have your loss function
which is equal our binary cross entropy
loss so we have losses
Dot or binary cross entropy and that's
it
so we have this set we could run this
now and then go ahead to uh train our
model by calling on again.feet method or
just model of fit method so we have
history equal again dot feet and then we
pass in our Trend data set uh we'll
start with say uh 10 or let's let's take
just a hundred elements first and then
your the number of ebooks equal uh
epochs which you've defined already and
then we have some callback so will you
make use of this callback and you you
already see the advantage of
overriding the train step method as now
we could just
um Define our callback and then pass it
in here and the job is done so we will
have this callback which is
I'm going to show us the generated
images at the end of an Epoch so uh
let's call it show image and it's going
to take in uh latent theme
okay so that's it everything looks fine
now the next thing we want to do is
Define this show image callback right
here uh here let's let's define this
callback just above here so we have
I show image callback and then we get
the latent Dimension and then we specify
on eBook and so at the end of every
ebook we are going to uh run this code
right here now what's going on here is
simple we have our model and then we
have the generator we take in some
random uh noise we pass it into our
generator and then we try to see what
the model is generating so this means
that uh when we're training or initially
we have some output or some fake data
generated by the generator and then
after an ebook we want to see what the
model is generating as we keep on
training our our complete model so this
that this is very important as we could
already be able to debug and understand
what's going on so this means that in a
case where the model is say for example
uh generating the same kinds of of
output or generating some outputs which
are clearly not the type of output we
will expect to get or whose distribution
is very far away from that of the real
data then we would have to take some
measures so it's very important to work
with these kinds of callbacks as the
already permit us to debug our whole
model training process so that said we
just have to specify the figure size
here and then what we're doing is we
we're having these different subplots
because we see we have 64. we could you
could reduce this or you could increase
just depends on you you could just pick
whatever you want to pick here so you
could generate a certain number of
um images
um yeah and it's equals six so we
regenerating six by six that's 36 images
so we could change this to 36 and then
now for each and every subplot we're
gonna show the image you see this out
this outcome from here so from the
generator and that's it now we're going
to save this figure in some in some
directory which we could visualize
so let's modify this let's take here to
be 36.
um that's fine let's run this we have
that show image that's fine
um everything looks fine now let's go
ahead and uh start with the train so we
could even reduce this to just stand so
that we could uh be able to notice any
errors quickly and then now train on the
full data set
we get in this error on expected keyword
argument mean vowel this actually mean
oh let's get back here without the
underscore so this is a year you have
this involved and here we have Maxwell
now you could feel free to check out the
documentation and you should find the
exact syntax so let's run this again and
then start with the training
I'll get in this errors
well you're told that no no gradients
are provided for a new variable and when
you look at this you'll notice that we
have come to the transposers uh this
means that most probably this error is
coming from the generator so let's get
back here and make sure everything is
okay uh one thing we notice here already
is that this should be G so yeah it
should be G and what do we have again
here
um yeah it looks fine so let's run this
again and then see what we get
we still get this error
which again shows that it's coming from
the generator we get back here and what
do we notice we notice here that we we
get this fake images out of the scope of
our gradient tape so what we have to do
is instead directly call this in your
so we we
want to update the parameters of the
generator so it has to be in this
gradient tape scope and not outside so
let's take this off
take that off and one question you may
be asking yourself is why is it possible
to just do this here that's have this
out but not in the generator and the
simple answer is for the discriminator
this generator isn't updated so it
doesn't matter if it's in here or not
whereas for the generator it actually
matters so we we have to measure it in
here so that's it let's run this again
and then see what we get
directory generated and all of that
anyway let's let's make uh this
directory generated
and then we run this again
there we go things seems to be working
fine you see that struggling to generate
some
um images let's open up our generator
here you see we have the different files
let's check out on say the 18th output
uh you see this already so you see it's
struggling already to produce you see
this image here
this one year looks really like so a
human face though it's still uh
struggling a lot so we have that let's
let's check out on say the 19th
oh there we go okay so that's it let's
close this hopefully there's no issue
with connection uh let's get back up and
then if those images aren't very visible
you can retrain and go for or take many
more samples so here we're dealing with
uh 100 we take a hundred and then after
Let's uh check this out after six epochs
you see the kind of results we get see
the the images we get already look like
humans now let's modify this code let's
stop the training and then let's modify
the code such that we do not flip the
levels
um there we go we could get back to this
flip thick levels and then instead of
once we just take the fake levels so
let's let's take zeros so if we have
this we're gonna compare it with when we
actually do the flipped labeling so
let's run this
um let's uh
we run the cells and then we start with
the train
after 9 epochs we can now check out
those generated images let's let's open
up the zero open up the third the feet
and then say the eight
um let's see what we get here see
you see this
our generators experiencing Vanishing
ingredients and that's why we're getting
these kinds of horrible outputs so let's
um again stop the training let's stop
the training and then let's get back to
our our models uh what we'll do now is
instead of using the Leaky relu we just
use a relu so let's let's change this
activation and set it to relu
there we go let's
um simply place this out everywhere and
then take off the Leaky relu and then
see the kind of output we would get in
case we we used the the the value itself
instead of the Liker
um let's take that off everything looks
fine now let's get back into the
generator and then repeat the same so
spaces out here radioactivation
um
take off leaky relu take off liquorello
and then rerun this again
um this should be fine now let's run
that and then see what we get
okay now that train has been going on
for a while now we could open up the
zero let's say open up the second the
feet the seventh
um and then the tenth so we could uh
look at this now what do you notice you
see we're getting practically not in as
output right here and that's simply
because we using the relu instead of the
Leaky relu
and as you can see sparsity isn't great
for generating images so you have to be
very careful with that now let's stop
this training
um stop the training and then uh get
back to what we had before
um we have this yeah this should be fine
uh no discriminator and then right here
get back again
and
oops let's get back then we restart the
training again and then see what we get
now that train has been going on for a
while let's go ahead and open this up
one uh yes zero take out two for example
five
um seven and say eight so let's check
out what the model is output and see
um there we go
we can see that with the normal value it
isn't doing that bad either so in this
specific example using the Leaky relu
isn't maybe oh that necessary okay so
now we've looked at the effect of not
using this leaky relu
um you could also or take off the batch
norm and see how that affects the kinds
of outputs you get from the generator
um yeah we're getting an error let's run
this again
yeah okay that's fine now let's go ahead
and uh restart the training but this
time around with a full data set so
let's take this off and then start with
the training after training for over 20
epochs here are the kinds of outputs we
shall be getting in our deep learning
for image generation course we delve
deep into how to create even much higher
quality outputs like this one for
example which was created with a
diffusion model
uh this Auto one which we created with a
program that's it for this section on
image generation with the variational
auto encoders and the generative
adversarial neural networks so we've
come to the end of this course and if
there's one thing we suggest you doing
is working on as many projects as
possible on your own so you could make
use of tools like tensorflow hog and
face 1db Onyx just to name a few to
build and deploy image segmentation
models object content models text
detection text recognition that
estimation image search engines post
estimation face recognition drowsiness
detection license plate recognition
object tracking and video classification
and if you want to take a deep dive into
natural language processing image
generation or object detection you could
check out those different courses on the
neural learn.i AI platform with that
said we wish you the very best as you
move forward in your career